this is a Harvard University course
taught by Dr David Meen and we are proud
to bring it to the freeo camp YouTube
channel throughout a series of lectures
Dr men will teach you how to think
algorithmically and solve problems
efficiently and make sure to check the
description for a lot of extra resources
that go along with the
[Music]
course
all right this is cs50 Harvard
University's introduction to the
intellectual Enterprises of computer
science and the Arts of programming my
name is David man and I actually took
this course myself back in 1996 I was a
sophomore at the time I was actually
concentrating in government because a
year prior as a first year I'd come into
Harvard thinking that I liked high stre
and constitutional law and sort of
similar classes in high school and so
when I got here I rather gravitated
toward that which was familiar I figured
if I liked and if I were good at that
particular subject in high school then
that's presumably who I'm supposed to be
here but it wasn't until sophomore year
that I got up the nerve to step foot in
the cs50 classroom and even then it was
only out of curiosity like I had no
intention of studying computer science
of even taking cs50 when I got to campus
but people were talking about it and
there was a lot of like beware and it
was it perhaps for the initiated only
and I didn't really know ultimately what
computer science was but for me the sort
of light bulb went off and I found that
contrary to what I had seen in high
school where I saw friends of mine like
programming away in the computer lab
heads down sort of anti-socially just
doing whatever it was they were doing it
really wasn't that once I got to this
particular class in this particular
place it was much more about problem
solving more generally and just learning
how to express yourself in code in
different languages so that you can
actually solve problems of interest to
you even if you have no intention of
being a computer scientist or an
engineer but just want to be able to
solve problems analyze data do
interesting things in the Arts Humanity
social sciences physical sciences or
really any other field and indeed this
particular path led me to computer
science but the hope for cs50 more
generally is that indeed you just find
your way to applying principles that
you'll learn over the coming months to
whatever field is of interest to you
with that said it was definitely a lot
of work and not without its frustrations
for me but there was no better feel
then like banging your head proverbial
against the wall for some number of
hours even days trying to fix a bug a
mistake in your code and then oh my God
the rush of emotion of accomplishment of
pride of exhaustion when you finally
solve some problem that's really been
weighing on you it's just so incredibly
gratifying but also empowering because
unlike a lot of fields the computer
science was built by humans themselves
and so if a human built this surely you
another human can understand it as well
and so even though there's going to be
some distractions along the way you're
going going to see what looks incredibly
cryptic if you've never programmed
before over time and with practice
everything just starts to make more
sense and with time and with practice
you just get better at this particular
field and indeed really the key to
success in programming in general is
just to allow yourself enough time and
so at least thankfully I quickly got
into the habit of starting early in the
week for instance when writing actual
code why because you're going to like
run up against a wall you're not going
to see some bug something's not going to
jump out at you and that's fine that's
when you sort of call it a day take a
break move move on to something else and
then just come back to it and that's
what keeps programming fund for me even
all of these years later whether it's
teaching or actually applying it but
there's uh down the road a history of uh
an MIT hack and it looked a little
something like this in yester year and
there was a little sign the MIT students
when they made this hack uh on the wall
that says getting an education from MIT
is like drinking from a fire hose which
indeed they have connected to what
should have been otherwise just a water
fountain and that's going to be what it
feels like sometimes not just in
computer science per se but just in UNAM
familiar field if you're not from stem
if you're not from CS that's fine but so
much of it ultimately is going to be
absorbed by you and going to be uh
within your grasp by term Zen so just
keep in mind that's that's very much the
intent but you'll be amazed what you're
able to create to accomplish uh just
three or so months hence indeed 2third
of you contrary to what you might think
or assume have never taken a CS class
before so it's absolutely not the case
that the person to the left and to the
right surely must know more than you
indeed it's quite the opposite and as
you'll see in the coming weeks as you
write your own code and solve your own
problems what ultimately matters in this
course is not so much where you end up
relative to your classmates but where
you end up relative to yourself when you
began and it really is all about that
Delta whether you've programmed or not
just getting something out of a class
like this and and if it does take time
and if you do feel those frustrations
but you simultaneously eventually feel
that sense of accomplishment that just
means it's all working and indeed
hopefully all the more worthwhile and
gratifying ultimately as a result so
what are we going to do in the coming
week so here we are in week zero we'll
soon see why computers and computer
scientists start counting if you will
from zero but week zero is which is one
in which we explore computational
thinking sort of thinking like a
computer and starting to clean up your
thought processes getting you to think
to solve problems more methodically and
then ultimately Translating that into
code and some of you might recognize
this environment here AKA scratch
coincidentally also from MIT you might
have used it in in grade school we'll
use it today and a little bit this
weekend in the course's first homework
assignment or problem set but not so
much to kind of play around in a way
that you might have if you did use it in
yester year but to explore ideas of
computer science and programming that
we're going to use and reuse every week
Hereafter as well uh thereafter we're
going to transition just next week to
week one so to speak whereby we'll
introduce you to a more traditional
language a lower level language an older
language called C and in C you're going
to use your keyboard not so much your
mouse and pointing and clicking but
you're going to write code that soon is
going to look a little something like
this and if you programmed before can
probably glean what this is going to do
if you've never programmed before which
is the case for most of you this too
will soon make sense but this is the
most canonical program that most any
programmer ever writes called hello
world and indeed that and all of the
surrounding syntax above and below just
that sentence hello world will soon make
all the more sense you'll learn how to
use industry standard tools so to speak
pictured here something called Visual
Studio code or vs code you'll use a
cloud-based version of it initially so
you don't have to suffer with any
technical difficulties or headaches like
that it'll just work right off the bat
but we'll use that tool and others
ultimately to then explore ideas in
computer science principles that you can
apply and we'll take a look underneath
the hood so to speak of your computer at
your memory or Ram Random Access Memory
where all of the data is ultimately
going to be stored we'll also take a
look thereafter at bugs a bug is a
mistake in a program here is an actual
bug in an actual computer in yester year
but we'll teach you how to debug
programs find your own mistakes find
others mistakes and improve that code as
well we'll transition then to algorithm
step-by-step instructions for solving
some problems which we'll touch on today
too and if you picture here this is
actually a pretty representative
problems odds are you haven't had to
deal with something like this but it's
representative sorting for instance if
you think of each of these small bars as
being a small number each of the bigger
bars as being a bigger number you might
wonder well how is you could do as a
human sort all of these bars like get
all the short bars over here all the big
bars over there well odds are if you're
like me you would probably kind of
eyeball it and if you could physically
interact you might just start grabbing
the smallest elements first put them
over on the left maybe grab the biggest
elements put them over on the right but
what's your algorithm there like how
would you teach someone younger than you
who's never done that before how to do
it how would you compel your Mac or PC
or phone to do something like that you
can't just kind of wave your hand and
say oh you know figure it out move
things around you have to express
yourself more methodically so we'll
translate even ideas like this into code
to and that's what the Googles and
others of the world are doing constantly
as they sort and organize the world's
information we'll use metaphors along
the way if it helps we'll talk about
your computer's memory is kind of being
like a postal address like every mailbox
in the world has some form of postal
address Street city state country and
the like and it turns out that's how
your Mac your PC and your phone also
work you've got a whole bunch of memory
like the picture before but you can
think of it really as individual
mailboxes and you can put anything you
want in those mailboxes and you can go
to a mailbox to grab information that
from it so at the end of the day that's
really all your computer's doing with
information it's just kind of organizing
it not into mailboxes per se but a term
you probably know called bites for
instance instead we'll talk about
problems that arise even nowadays in
fact most of you are familiar with your
Mac PC even phone like spontaneously
rebooting sometimes crashing the little
Annoying spinning beach ball or
Hourglass Icon that Happ like what is
with that well those are just bugs in
programs that humans at Apple and Google
and Microsoft and others they screwed up
and they wrote buggy code and your
computer when it encounters those
mistakes doesn't know what to do and so
nine times out of 10 so to speak it just
crashes or freezes or the like but that
kind of stuff will make more sense so
even the real world will make sense and
pictured here or some lower level terms
will eventually get to Mid semester but
generally speaking when something is
going this way as per this arrow and
something is going this way as per this
Arrow like that does not end well and
that often is what happens when your
computer crashes someone's using memory
up here but someone else is using memory
down here here and then they're not
really talking left hand and right hand
so that is just a high level overview of
some of the problems we'll encounter but
we'll focus to on data ultimately so
picture here is something fairly
technical called a hash table it's an
amalgam of something we're going to soon
call an array and also something we call
a linked list and these are just fancy
terms for describing how you can
organize information even more flexibly
than just putting individual ma values
in mailboxes like how could you build
structures like actual data structures
so to speak speak two-dimensional
structures at that and so what you're
seeing here is a glimpse uh as some of
you might have recognized of some Harry
Potter Universe names but they're
organized somewhat alphabetically and
notice that anytime there's multiple
people with a name that starts with H
like hermion Harry and Hagrid well they
can't all fit in that mailbox if each of
these squares along the left is that
same mailbox so you have to kind of
chain them together well you'll learn
how to do that in code so that even if
you get more data than you expect if
your business is booming and you're some
web-based business how do you keep
adding and adding information to your
software to actually keep up with it but
this again is what codee's going to soon
look like as soon as next week in week
one this here being C but we'll
transition in a few weeks to a more uh
modern higher level language so to speak
called python indeed the course Very
deliberately back in my day and now this
introduces you first to C which funny
enough most many people don't tend to
program and certainly every day I you
see generally September October November
December when teaching C is 50 itself
but it's everywhere nonetheless in fact
even today's other languages with which
you might be familiar like Python and
Java and uh yet others still you see
this same primitive language underneath
the hood because it's so darn fast and
as you'll learn over the coming weeks it
really gives you access to and an
understanding of what's going on
conceptually down here so that
thereafter after cs50 when you're
writing code you can sort of think at a
very high level what's actually going on
so in fact in just a few weeks what
looks like this C is going to look
instead like this in Python and you'll
better understand what's going on
underneath the hood and odds are after
this class you'll reach for a language
like python more frequently than C but
you're going to benefit from that bottom
up understanding thereof thereafter and
toward terms end we'll introduce you to
a few other ideas like where do you put
large amounts of data in things called
databases not things like spreadsheets
like here but actual databases where
using those same kinds of data
structures you lay things out in an
interesting way in memory thereafter
will transition to a very familiar
environment that you and I use every day
the web like the web has become rather
the user interface or UI that we use
everywhere on the uh laptops desktops
and even mobile devices nowadays well
pictured here is a language called HTML
it's not a programming language it's a
markup language and some of you might
have made homepages or portfolios in the
past but you'll understand what's going
on here but more powerfully you'll
understand how the computer sees that
same kind of code builds up a
hierarchical family tree type structure
in memory and then you can manipulate
that tree with code to actually add more
and more information chat messages
anything on the screen that you like and
finally we'll tie all of this together
by introducing what are called
Frameworks and libraries third-party
code that makes it a lot easier to solve
problems of interest to you and so in
particular here this is the very first
web app that I myself made back in like
1997 I was part of the first year
intramural sports program not as an
athlete but as the programmer and I was
teaching myself how to build web
applications I only knew C and maybe a
little bit of something else at the time
but this became for Harvard at least the
very first website for the first year uh
intramural sports program and it wasn't
just a static website with links and
images and the like it was interactive
you could register for sports we could
input exactly who is in a tournament
bracket or the leg and it could actually
automatically keep track of this data so
there two after just three months of a
class like this you'll go from writing
quite simply this week in next hello
world to building things like this for
whether it's web mobile uh or other
platforms as well if you so choose but
we'll get you off of the courses
infrastructure by the end of the term
you won't be using any toy environments
along the way will Empower you
ultimately to write code after cs50
especially if this is the only CS class
you ever take on your own Mac or PC
using the same software but not the
cloud-based version thereof but all of
this software is itself free and can be
used by you uh powerfully after the
course's own end but along the way as
you may know uh is there this tradition
within the class particularly in healthy
times of a number of events that really
brings people get together not just
collaboratively academically but to just
solve problems and generally uh engage
with each other as well coming up first
cs50 puzzle day which is meant to be not
jigsaw puzzles but logic puzzles that
require no prior experience with
computer science or programming but it's
just an opportunity to sort of quietly
work on a packet of puzzles with some
number of friends for for prizes and
more later the semester once you tackle
your final projects the Capstone of the
course where we don't give you a
homework to write you yourself come up
with something to build we'll get
together generally around 7 a uh 700
p.m. in the evening uh wrap up around 7
a.m. if you so choose and it's an
evening a 12-hour opportunity to
collaborate with classmates on your very
own final project in a large space on
campus uh that ends if you're awake with
us at 5:00 a.m. uh we can hop on some
cs50 shuttles and go down the road for
some pancakes at IHOP around 6 uh of
course uh of course this is 6 7 a.m. at
that point but it's an opportunity
finally to lead into What's called the
cs50 fair which is an end of semester
celebration an exhibition of everything
that you'll accomplish over the coming
months and in fact pictured here are
some of your predecessors and healthy
times um the cs50 fair allows you to
come with your laptop or phone and
exhibit a students faculty and staff
across campus put together something in
person and on video that people can
Delight in seeing as you exhibit what it
is you create in what you learned over
the course of the several weeks and
ultimately a chance to just share and
Inspire others as well um and you'll all
walk home ultimately with your own I to
cs50 t-shirt saying as much as well so
with that highlevel overview of the
course I propose that we begin to take a
look at what computer science itself is
and what it is we're going to be doing
over the next several weeks at this
lower level than two so what is computer
science right if you're maybe like me or
new people like my friends and High
School you probably assume that it means
programming and that's absolutely a big
part of it for a lot of people because
with code you can write you can express
ideas and solve actual problems
especially involving data but computer
science itself is really the study of
information if you will how do you
represent it and how do you actually
process it and in that sense
computational thinking is just the
application of ideas from computer
science a course like this to problems
of interest to you again in the Arts
Humanities Sciences social sciences
whatever the domain interest is to you
so with that if computer science is all
about information and with it the
solving of problems well what does it
actually mean to solve a problem let's
see if we can't propose a model into
which all of the Lessons Learned will
ultimately follow and I'd propose that
this is problem solving you've got some
input which is like the problem you want
to solve the goal is to solve it so
that's the so-called output and then
somewhere in here the proverbial black
box is some kind of Secret Sauce that
gets the work done and in the coming
months have to decide well how are we
going to represent these inputs and
outputs and really how do we code up how
do we write solutions for what it is
that's solving the problem of interest
to us so when it comes to representation
of information like there's a lot of
ways we can do this and for instance if
the problem at hand quite simply is to
like take attendance at the beginning of
class on the first day of school well
how could we go about doing this well we
could actually use a system called unary
well what is that well that's a fancy
way of saying 1 2 3 4 5 maybe 6 7 8 9 10
and I can use my digits pun intended on
my fingers to actually count everyone up
and eventually you need toes and whatnot
if you have to count so high but unary
is a very simple system of using a
single symbol a human finger in this
case to just solve some problem like
counting the number of people in the
room let's make this slightly more
technical for a moment a little more
mathy that's just called base one where
the base under which you're operating
has one digit in it like literally a
human finger and maybe multiple such
fingers if you need to count higher but
of course of course all most of you if
not all of you generally vaguely know
that computers use something other than
unary and even you and I probably don't
use this that often they use what
language or alphabet
instead yeah so binary so binary is
indeed the system that computers somehow
use so in this case by implying two and
so computers have two digits it turns
out at their dispos one in fact if
you've ever heard the technical term bit
which is like a smaller version of a
bite more on that soon well a binary
digit is the origin of that term bit
because if you get rid of some of the
letters and you're left from binary
digit with just bit thus is a bit a bit
is just a zero and one it's two more
digits than you might have on your own
finger and of course it's fewer though
than you and I have you and I typically
use as humans the decimal system deck
meaning 10 because you and I generally
use zero through nine so on the one hand
another pun intended you've got unary
computers use binary we humans generally
think and talk in terms of De
but at the end of the day these are
fundamentally going to be the same thing
which is to say that it's all pretty
accessible to us even if you're not a
computer person I dare say you're about
to be so what is a bit well a bit then
is a zero or a one that is a so-called
binary digit but how do computers only
speak in binary how do they solve
problems represent information using
only binary well at the end of the day
if they want to represent zero and one
we need to do so physically somehow and
I dare say that maybe the simplest way
to think about a bit a zero or one is
like a light bulb and so by human
convention let's just assume that if you
are a computer be it a laptop desktop
phone or the like and you want to
represent the number zero you know what
you just keep a light switch off you
keep a light bulb off if by contrast
you're that same computer and you want
to represent the number one you take
that same switch that same light bulb
and just turn it on so a light bulb
that's on represents a one and a light
bulb that's off represents a zero so why
is this relevant into computers well at
the end of the day you and I are
charging our laptops or phones at night
so there's some like physical resource
being replenished there whether you're
on battery or some power cord and so a
inside of a computer are just thousands
millions of tiny little switches
nowadays you can think of them
metaphorically as light bulbs but they
don't yet it's actually shine light but
there are tiny tiny little switches and
those switches if you've ever heard the
term are just called transistors so like
computers have millions of transistors
that can either be flipped on to
represent ones or flipped off to
represent zeros and from that very
simple mechanism electricity is there or
it's not a one or a zero computers can
actually count obviously from zero to
one but it turns out even higher if they
use a little more electricity as well so
how might I do this well let me go ahead
and propose that I just grab one of our
own light bulbs here on stage this one's
off so for instance If This Were
miniaturized inside of your Mac PC or
phone this would be a transistor and
indeed here's the little switch on the
bottom and if your computer wants to
represent a zero it just leaves the
switch off and the light is not shining
if you want to represent a one well now
I've counted as high as one because the
switch is now on I've grabbed a little
electricity I'm holding on to it inside
of the computer and so now I see that
this is a one all right but
unfortunately with just one switch one
light bulb I can only count from zero to
one how do I count out higher might you
think
intuitively say again yeah so more light
bulbs so let me do this let me just put
grab something to put these on so I can
use a few of them at a time and let me
propose that here instead of having just
one light bulb let me give myself maybe
three in total so all of them are
initially off and if you think of this
in miniature form in your mind's eye
this is like a computer with three
transistors three switches representing
now the number you and I know as zero
why they're just all off so how does a
computer go about representing the
number one well it turns on one of these
light bulbs and how does the computer
represent the number two well you might
think if I by may you just turn on a
second light bul and if you might think
how does a computer represent three you
just turn on the third light bulb and so
as such with three bits a computer would
seem to be able to count from zero on up
to 1 two three but it turns out if I'm a
little smarter here I can actually count
higher than that why well I'm just
considering like the combination of
bulbs being on here what if I do
something like this this is still zero I
will claim but what if I propose now
that this will be how a computer
represents one on on off off this though
will be how the computer represents two
notice I didn't turn on the same two I'm
just turning on the one in the middle
this I now claim will be how a computer
represents three this is going to be in
just a second how a computer represents
the number we know as four and yet I'm
still only using three bulbs this is
going to be the number the computer
represents as five this is going to be
how the computer represents the number
six and then lastly it turns out with
three light bulbs if you're smart about
it you can count it seems as high as
seven now even if you kind of lost track
of like what I was turning on and Y I
claimed there were eight different
patterns from all of them off to all of
them on but notice that I started to
permute them I took into account which
ones were on and which ones were off why
though do these represent the numbers we
know as 0 through 7even well let me go
ahead and maybe let's let's do this
instead of just considering there to be
light bulbs let's assign some special
significance to each of them based on
where it is and maybe for this could we
get uh maybe three volunteers three
volunteer okay yeah who's you're being
volunteered okay come on up if you want
to go over to the stage there yeah you
want to come on up as well and over here
as well so there's some stairs on either
end maybe a round of applause for our
first volunteers of
term all right so you want to be you are
number one and if you want want to go
ahead and stand roughly right here how
about you want to be number two okay
come on over and right uh to the right
of here and you'll be number four it
turns out and if you want to come over
here on this end let's give you all a
moment to uh introduce yourselves uh
briefly to your classmates if you'd like
hi I'm Ellie I'm a senior nice to meet
I'm rahana and I'm a first year welcome
hi I'm Joseph and I am a first year
welcome all right so so glad to have all
three of you up here thank
you let me propose now that we'd like
you you three to represent how about the
number zero and I claim now that if each
of you now represents a switch you have
sort of fancier light bulbs now one is a
one one is a two one is a four but each
of you still just has a switch on the
bottom in fact of your plastic devices I
claim these three volunteers are
representing the number zero let me ask
you all now how might you represent the
number one how should you cooperate here
okay so so we would have on off off
which I think is matches what I did with
my three light bulbs as well if you want
to go ahead and turn yours off how might
you three represent the number
two okay so off on off now from right to
left how would you3 represent the number
three ah so that's why my two light
bulbs went on at the end how would you
three represent the number
four perfect number
five number six
and number
seven all right and give us one more how
would you represent
eight okay you can't uh how about then
one more volunteer one more volunteer
okay come on
up all right what's your name my name is
Moen if you want to say it there my name
is Moen all right Moen you're GNA be
number eight and if now you all actually
let's make this uh how would you
represent number eight all collectively
as four bits or four
switches okay eight and now lastly give
me
15 everyone's awkwardly doing arithmetic
in their head oh using
unar hey yeah is
everyone yes okay Round of Applause okay
thank you
all if you want to leave your numbers
over here we have a 650 stress ball for
you but thank you for volunteer you can
turn those numbers off and leave them
over here so thank
you so how do we go about how do we go
from there to uh creating these patterns
well even though we still had three bits
initially and three switches later four
bits and four switches ultimately we
still used it used the same approach
fundamentally to actually representing
information and now why were they those
patterns and why did I very deliberately
have our volum volunteers line up in
that way well I wanted them using base 2
AKA binary but with binary there come
certain rules and even if you're not
familiar with binary beyond that it
exists and relates somehow to computers
it's actually pretty much identical to
the system you and I use every day known
as base 10 AKA decimal so let's consider
if you will by rewinding to primary
school for just a moment like how
decimal works and you'll see that even
if you're not a computer person you
actually are you just have to tweak your
mental model ever so slightly so here is
the number that you're probably viewing
as 123 but why is that well it's not
really 123 these are just uh this is
just a pattern of three symbols on the
screen 1 2 three and your mind is sort
of rapidly assigning mathematical
meaning to them 123 but why is that well
if you're like me you probably learned
back in the day when you have a
three-digit number like this the
rightmost number is in the ones place
the middle digit is the 10 place the
leftmost digit is in the hundreds place
and why is that relevant well if you
then quickly do some mental math as you
and I just do uh instantly nowadays that
just means 100 * 1 plus 10 * 2 plus 1 *
3 of course 100 + 20 + 3 gives us the
number you and I know as
123 but beyond that how do we get to
just two digits instead of as many as
nine in the decimal system well let's
generalize this in the decimal system
you and I know if we've got three digits
represented by these hashes here yes
it's the ones place T Place hundreds
place and if we keep going thousands 10
thousands and so forth but why is that
well base terminology is now a little
more gerine that's technically the 10 to
the zero column the 10 to the 1 10 to
the two so these are powers of 10 where
10 is your base computers just simplify
things a little bit because computers at
the end of the day only have access to
electricity on or off they don't have
access to like 10 different types of
electricity just two on or off if you
will well they just use a different base
and the rightmost digit would be in the
so-called 2 to the zero then the middle
digit is 2 to the one the leftmost is 2
to the 2 AKA one's Place two's Place
Four's place and as we kept going 8 and
if we keep going 16 32 64 128 and so
forth but the idea is fundamentally the
same so why is this how the computer
represents the number you and I know is
zero well off off off from right to left
or in this case left to right is just
zero why CU that's 4 * 0 + 2 * 0 + 1
time 0 is of course 0o this is why 0 01
represents one this is why 0 1 0
represents two and three and four and
five and six and seven on up and why did
we need a fourth bit to represent eight
well we kind of needed to carry the one
so to speak using our human familiar uh
familiar human terminology but for that
we need a fourth bit another transistor
and this now represents the number eight
and that's why we ended with on from
left to right off off off so I keep
saying on and off or the light bulb is
on or off but really I just mean one or
zero and so computers and we humans
think of things digitally as just being
zeros and ones but mechanically you can
think of it indeed as these light bulbs
now a bit not very useful even three
bits four bits not that useful you can
count to seven or 15 generally speaking
bites are a more useful unit of measure
and anyone familiar how many bits is in
a bite yeah so eight bits are in a bite
can think of it as an octet equivalently
uh in some context there are nuances
there but think of a bite as just being
eight bits and that's just a more useful
measure so what does this mean in real
terms well if you've ever downloaded
like a music file or a photograph or a a
video those are measured in bytes
probably not small numbers of bytes
probably kilobytes for thousands of
bytes megabytes for millions of bytes
gigabytes for billions of bytes
especially for video that just means you
have a lot of patterns of 8 Bits some
combination of zeros and ones on your
computer's hard drive here then with a
bite of bits eight bits is how a
computer would typically represent the
number zero and if that same computer
uses all eight of its bits it's full
bite to rep uh to change it to one
anyone who's quick with math or have
seen this before how high can a computer
count with eight bits or one yeah 255
why is that well we're not going to turn
this into a constant math exercise
indeed after today we're not really
going to think about or talk about bits
at this low level but this is the ones
place 2os 4S 8 16 32 64 128 and if I do
all of that math from left to right that
indeed gives me
255 it ignores how we might represent
negative numbers but perhaps more on
those some other day but computers of
course do so much more than numbers and
math and all this lowlevel stuff we send
text messages right documents emails and
the like so how might a computer
represent something like the letter A I
claim at the end of the day your Mac
your PC your phone just has lots of
transistors lots of switches that it can
use in units of eight in units of bytes
how though if it's already using those
patterns of zeros and ones apparently to
represent numbers from zero on up how do
you go about representing letters of the
alphabet might you think yeah okay so we
could assign a number to every letter
okay so let me just conjecture well
let's just call a0 for Simplicity B1 1
C2 and now let me play Devil's Advocate
okay how do I now represent zero or one
or two well we've maybe created a
problem for oursel if now we have to
steal some numbers to represent letters
we kind of have to pick a lane but
there's a solution to that too that
we'll see and it turns out the world is
not quite as simple as a being zero a
typically is represented by computers
everywhere phones everywhere with the
number 65 the decimal number 65 using 8
Bits if we turn some of the zeros to
ones let me just stipulate you can
represent the letter A Using eight bits
by turning certain ones on and certain
ones off but we will try not to focus on
the that binary level too much so if a
is 65 it turns out that b is going to be
66 and C is going to be 67 and so forth
and so where does that get us well it
turns out there's a whole system that
Maps uh numbers to letters and here uh
as I alluded to verbally a moment ago is
the pattern of zeros and ones via which
you'd represent 65 and just quick check
here we won't constantly do math uh
one's place that's easy 2os Four's 8 16
32 64's place so 64 + 1 gives us
65 so once I do that how do I get to all
of the others well it turns out a bunch
of Americans years ago came up with this
asky the American Standard code for
information interchange now what does
that mean well it's just an acronym
describing what really you proposed a
mapping between numbers and letters not
not quite as simple as 012 starts at 65
66 67 for capital letters but here are
most of the letters in use today at
least with this system so this is just a
big chart from online and you'll see it
in the middle of this chart here here's
my 65a here's my 66 b c and let's see 72
is H 73 is I and so forth so there's a
mapping at least for English between all
of these numbers and all of these
letters and if we focus here those are
the beginning of our up case alphabet so
suppose then that today tomorrow you
receive a text message from someone and
underneath the hood now that you're a
computer person you figure out a way to
see what pattern of zeros and ones was
sent in this case it's wireless as
opposed to wired but it's still some
pattern of zeros and ones and your phone
is turning some switches of its own on
and off to represent that message from a
friend suppose that the three patterns
you received were these three btes from
left to right spelling out a
three-letter word well if if we do out
the math one's Place two's place and so
forth I'll spoil it for you suppose that
you received a text message that doesn't
literally say 72 73 33 but you've
received a pattern of 8 plus 8 plus 8 24
bits that if you do out the math
represent the decimal number 72 73 33
anyone recall what message you might
have received from the green and white
charts
yeah hi but yes hi is the message but
7273 gives H and I what's 33 any any
guesses to
33 yeah over here yeah so it's an
exclamation point how would you know
that well you really do need some kind
of cheat sheet AKA aski in this case and
if we look elsewhere let me highlight
the left of the chart you can see that
next to 33 in decimal is indeed the
exclamation point so back in the day a
bunch of humans got in a room decided
that hey when we start building PCS and
later Macs and phones we all just have
to agree on this form of representation
of letters of the the English alphabet
in this case we just need to agree on
this mapping but somewhat curiously
notice this it turns out that once you
paint yourself into this corner and
start using 65 for a 66 for B well how
do you represent 65 the number and 66
the number if you want to do math or use
Excel or something like that does anyone
kind of see the solution perhaps how do
you represent the number one in asy yeah
in the
middle yeah so this is getting a little
maybe Inception or something but you
could represent numbers with other
numbers and so if you want to represent
the number you and I know as one like
when you type it on your keyboard turns
out the computer stores that as the
decimal number 49 if you hit two on your
keyboard the computer is not storing two
per se it's storing the decimal number
50 now thankfully the the uh the uh the
the Paradox kind of stops there we just
have a mapping now of numbers to to
numbers but really at the end of the day
and you're going to learn this when we
start writing code in that other
language C next week it's just context
dependent at the end of the day inside
of your Mac PC and phone there's just
all of these permutations of bits all of
these patterns of zeros and ones and
generally speaking when you open up a
text message that you've received from
someone it's zeros and ones but
obviously if it's a text message the
whole point of text messages is to send
text and so those patterns of zeros and
ones by default will typically be
interpreted as letters of the alphabet
so you won't see zeros and ones you
won't see decimal numbers you'll see the
English message that your friend
intended by contrast if you open up
something like Excel that same pattern
of zeros and ones might indeed work out
to be 6 uh 72 73 33 you might see cells
in your spreadsheet with literally those
three numbers why because spreadsheets
are all about numbers and number
crunching and math uh in many cases if
by contrast you open up Photoshop and
try to look at that same pattern of
zeros and ones it's not going to be 727
73 33 it's not going to be zeros and
ones it's not going to be high it's
going to be some color of the rainbow
you're going to use those patterns of
zeros and ones it turns out too to
represent colors and indeed so long as
you and I just agree as humans long have
what these patterns are going to be all
of our systems many of our systems
nowadays are indeed interoperable but
I'm being very biased here and indeed
the a in ASI is very American Centric
what do you not see in this chart if you
speak any other language in English odds
are you're not seeing characters you
know and love and need every day to type
or send messages well there's a huge
character set that's not supported here
whether it's accented characters and a
lot of Asian alphabets you have many
more symbols than can fit even on this
screen here and so humans kind of
painted themselves into a corner early
on or really Americans did but on a
typical keyboard us English keyboard
yeah you have A's and B's and C's
uppercase and lowercase but you also
have accented characters here and
nowadays not sure if this is maybe
necessary but nowadays you have other
characters on your keyboard like these
and these are kind of a playful
incarnation of what's actually a
technical solution to this problem if I
claim for the moment that ASI
historically used seven bits to
represent letters and let's just round
that up to a bite eight bits to
represent letters aski can represent as
many as 255 or really
256 total characters why 256 well if you
have them all zero that's zero and the
highest number I claimed a moment AG go
was 255 so that's 256 total
possibilities that's not many letters
it's fine for English but not a lot of
human languages so what might the
intuitive solution be if you want to
represent accented characters um Asian
characters Emoji even like these which
are just keys on a keyboard
nowadays what's the intuitive solution
if a bite's too few
yeah yeah so add another digit just like
we had a fourth volunteer come on up to
give us a fourth bid let's just throw
throw Hardware at the problem and use a
few more bits so maybe instead of one
bite let's use two or heck let's use
three or four bytes even though it's
getting a little expensive we're going
from 8 to 16 to 24 or 32 bits that's how
computers do things these days and
thankfully we have so much memory inside
of our computers and phones we can
certainly spare a few to represent these
things and the solution then to aski is
what we'll call Unicode so Unicode is
also just a mapping of letters to num of
numbers to letters but in many many
different languages and indeed the
Unicode Consortium is a bunch of people
from all different companies and and uh
and a lot of different uh companies and
countries and cultures whose mission as
an organization is to capture digitally
all forms of human language in this case
and to ensure that especially smaller
demographics of humans speaking lesser
known languages are nonetheless
represented and preserve digitally using
some mapping of these zeros and ones it
turns out though if you start using 32
bits as many as 32 bits to represent
characters on a keyboard that's 4
billion possible permutations of zeros
and ones that's way more than we need
for most human languages so there's a
little bit of room in there for some of
those more playful things like those
Emoji so for instance suppose you got a
text message with this pattern of zeros
and
ones or if we do out the math suppose
you receive a text message that if you
do out the math in decimal is 4 B 36
m991 106 anyone know what emoji you're
looking
at this would be weird if you do
but what is this Well turns out that as
of this past year this is the most
popular Emoji to be sent uh by many
measures face with tears of joy so that
is the pattern that a bunch of humans in
the Unicode Consortium decided would
represent this but you'll notice some
many of you might have iPhones some of
you might have Android devices too and
sometimes these don't actually look
quite the same this happens to be the
current version of face with tears of
joy on iOS on Android it tends to look a
little something more like this and
here's kind of a curiosity even though
you and I look at these things and they
look like images they're not images
they're characters at least as we've
defined them now in Unicode and a IOS
and Android and Windows and Facebook and
other companies and uh apps nowadays
really just have different fonts if you
will so just like fonts with English and
other languages can give you different F
characters with seraps or not emoji are
themselves yes drawings that someone
made but they're really just a font and
so that same pattern of zeros and ones
might just render slightly differently
on someone's phone or another if you've
ever gotten like an icon on your phone
that's broken and you've been sent an
emoji but it's like a square or
something arbitrary and not sensical
sensible it might just mean that you
have not updated to the latest version
of iOS or Android which just updates the
font of supported Emoji because those
Folks at Unicode pretty much every year
nowadays are adding more and more Emoji
to that that particular character said
now I went down the rabbit hole figuring
out the other day just which are the
most popular Emoji these days on Twitter
specifically this past year the most
popular Emoji by contrast uh was loudly
crying face I don't know if that says
more about 20121 or about Twitter but
you'll see different Trends certainly in
how these are used but even humans
themselves didn't necessarily think two
steps ahead and now a lot of the Emoji
are the sort of default yellow color but
there's a lot of emoji that aren't sort
of these cartoon characters but they're
meant to represent humans in various
professions or gestures or the like and
nowadays too you've probably noticed on
your phone and Macs and PCs there are
different skin tones that you can assign
to certain emojis if it's supported by
the company and by Unicode you can
actually like touch and hold on a
certain emoji and then you can choose
the appropriate skin tone to represent
yourself or someone else and that then
modifies the display well let's just
think for a moment here how did Apple
and Google and Microsoft and others go
about implementing support for emoji
with different skin tones how could you
do this if you want to represent some
smiling Emoji but in five in this case
different skin tones you could come up
with what five different patterns that
are identical structurally except for
the skin tone used in places in that
image but that's a little inefficient
right to kind of just do copy paste
paste paste paste and like change the
color in Photoshop if you will that's
going to use more bits more information
than you might need to how else if you
now start to think a little bit more
like a computer scientist if at the end
of the day all you have are zeros and
ones how else could you implement skin
tones might you think
yeah okay so RGB and we'll come to that
in just a moment that stands for red
green blue that's one way in this case
though I'm seeking an alternative to
just using five different patterns of
zeros and ones to represent the same
Emoji but different skin tones so not
quite RGB
yeah okay so store one copy of the Emoji
and then store different variants of the
color that you want to assign to that
emoji yeah so this is actually an
example of do you want to
elaborate okay so you can use a loop to
actually output these things more on
that in a moment let me go down this
this road for just a moment this would
be in some sense sort of a a better
design if you will uh but why yeah
filter okay so filter if we think sort
of in the Instagram sense you can sort
of change the color of something and
that could be related here too could it
be oh interesting so maybe it could be
just a completely different font and you
have five different fonts that are
almost identical except for the various
interpretations of skin tone for those
same Emoji let me spoil I think if we go
down this one particular Road the way
the uh the Unicode folks decided to do
this some years ago were the first uh
bite or bites that you receive via text
or email just represent like the
structure of the Emoji the default
Yellow Version thereof but if it's
immediately followed by a certain
pattern of bits that these humans
standardize to represent each of these
different shades of skin tone then the
phone the Mac the PC will change that
default color yellow in most cases to
whatever the more apt human tone is so
you just use twice as many bits but you
don't use five times as many bits so
what do I mean you don't have uh five
completely distinct patterns per se uh
for each of these possible variants you
have a representation of just the Emoji
itself structurally and then uh reusable
pattern patterns for those five skin
tones un um unfortunately that wasn't
quite versatile enough for other
features that were in the pipeline and
nowadays too and there's a double
meaning now to representation emojis had
tended to focus on certain professions
and early on too were certain
professions associated with certain
genders and vice versa and you couldn't
necessarily be one gender or another in
a certain profession or another there
were these combinatorics that just
weren't possible but nowadays as you
might have seen you can have couples in
love for instance that actually look a a
little more like three emojis but just
kind of combined into one and indeed
this is just one key press on your phone
and you can combine different emoji on
the left and in the right with the Emoji
in the middle and so it turns out how
computers nowadays represent these
patterns are one set of bits for the
character on the left one set of bits
for a character on the right one set of
bits for whatever Emoji you want in the
middle and then you assemble more
complicated compositions of emoji by
just reusing those same patterns and
bits and bits Emoji doesn't the Unicode
folks don't have to come up with a whole
new representation for some very
specific Incarnation they can create one
for person for male for female for other
uh characters that you might want to
display and reuse those same patterns of
zeros and ones and so here you see sort
of the imperfection of or lack of
foresight of humans for building a
system early on that was entirely
American Centric no characters Emoji or
the like that's evolved too and so
that's an important detail in Computing
nowadays um it too is evolved in and the
languages you're about to learn in the
coming days those twoo are evolving as
well and new features are getting added
and even programming languages have
version numbers you might have a
different version of an app on your
phone programming languages too have
different versions as well questions
then thus far and how information is
represented using asy or
Unicode or anything in between yeah so
you can use a string of a good question
so to recap why can't you just um well
let me summarize that as why can't you
similarly use different patterns to
change the context of what these
patterns of bits represent whether it's
a number or a letter or a graphic in
actuality that's kind of what's
Happening underneath the hood it's not
standardized in quite the same way but
starting next week when we transition
from scratch to C you'll learn about
types data types where the onus
initially is going to be on you the
programmer to tell the program whether
or not this pattern of bit should be
interpreted as a number or as a letter
or as a color or something else nowadays
though in toward the end of the semester
you'll use languages like python where
the computer just figures it out for you
by context which makes it even easier
and faster to program as well other
questions on Unicode asky or the
like all right well how about just a few
other forms of information RGB was
called out earlier red green blue How do
images get represented in computers well
in fact it's typically an assembly of
some amount of red some amount of green
some amount of blue but there are other
representations if you're a graphic
designer you might know them but RGB is
still pretty common what does this mean
this means to represent every dot on
your phone or every dot on your TV or
your laptop or desktop there is a number
representing how much red that dot
should show a number representing how
much green and a number representing how
much blue it should show red green blue
respectively so for instance if a DOT on
your screen were using these three
numbers these three values or bytes 72
73 33 in a text message email that would
be interpreted as I claimed high but in
Photoshop or in some graphical program
that same pattern would be repres would
be interpreted as let's call it a medium
amount of red a medium amount of green
and a little bit of blue and why medium
and little turns out that each of these
are bites the smallest value you can
have in a bite we said is zero the
largest value you can have in a bite is
255 so I'm just kind of spitballing here
this is like medium medium and a low
amount of red green blue uh specifically
those three colors um like uh
wavelengths of light are combined in
such a way that you would have this dot
on the screen a sort of murky shade of
yellow or brown that is how a computer
would store precisely that color and in
fact we've seen this color when you type
in face with tears of joy generally on
your screen it looks like this typically
much smaller but let's zoom in or let's
zoom in a little more what do you
starting to see if you know the term so
pixels it's getting very pixelated a
pixel is just a DOT on the screen and if
you really zoom in on it you can
literally see all of the dots that
compose in emoji in this case on iOS in
the font that Apple's using to represent
this particular pattern of zeros and
ones so one of those yellow dots and
there's many of them all that kind of
blend together here each dot on the
screen I claim is three bytes how much
red green blue for this dot how much red
green blue for this dot how much red
green blue for this Dot and you'll
notice too that when it gets to be sort
of brownish here the dots really stand
out the three values the three bytes AKA
24 bits are just slightly different and
so underneath the hood this is why
images photographs that you take or GIFs
that you download get so darn big
potentially because you have a number
representing every dot on the screen
well if this I claim is indeed how
images are typically represented using
pattern of bits that are assigned to
some amount of red green or blue how do
you get video what is a video if at the
end of the day all we have are zeros and
ones
what's a video perhaps yeah oh let's go
here weighing back yeah pixel's really
changing values over time and do you
want to confirm or deny the hand that
went up here yeah or equivalently a
sequence of images that over time are
changing on the screen so both of those
are valid interpretations and you know
just for fun if you uh grew up with
these sort of picture books you might
remember a little something like this if
we could dim the
[Music]
lights
so that's sort of the old school analog
way to implement a video in the sense
that um that artist wrote out like
hundreds of pieces of paper with almost
identical images but where the ink from
their pencil or pen was slightly moving
and if you digitize that such that each
of those Strokes are represented with
dots instead that's really what you're
seeing as a sequence of all these images
flying across the screen and if we dive
into the the real world if you've ever
watched a film a Hollywood movie is
typically 24 FPS frames per second that
really means you're seeing 24 images per
second or on TV or in soap operas it's
often 30 frames per second that makes
things look a little more smooth so it's
not actual motion picture if you will it
sequences of pictures and your brain and
mind are kind of interpolating that oh
this is smooth movement even though
we're just seeing a lot of pictures
really fast now that gets really big and
we'll talk later in the semester how you
can compress information so that you're
not using way more bits than you
actually need to and there's fancy
algorithms that folks have developed but
at the end of the day that's really all
a video might be is a sequence of images
conversely if you want to represent the
music that accompanies that or something
else if any of you play an instrument
and can read sheet music How Could You
digitize this like how could you
represent musical notes in a computer
you and I hear them when we play files
but what's really going on underneath
the
hood any any musicians piano players
anyone yeah Val okay so Hertz value so
some frequency so sound is some
frequency and it's kind of hitting your
eardrum and that's what makes it sound
low or high or somewhere in between so
maybe we could assign just like there's
letters a through G here maybe we could
assign specific frequency values which
are just going to be numbers measured in
something called Hertz something per
second and maybe we could have a few
other numbers for each of these notes
not just the note or the frequency maybe
we could represent the loudness of it
like how hard or how softly a human
might equivalently press it maybe a
third number like duration like how long
is their finger on the keyboard so you
could imagine quantizing something like
music that in the real world is
perfectly continuous as something more
discret by representing each note over
time as just some sequence of values and
there's so many different ways to do
this midi if you've heard uh MP3s AAC I
mean almost all the file extensions you
see on your Mac or PC if you see them at
all ultimately just mean there's a
different form of representation for in
this case something like sound so let me
just stipulate there are these and many
more ways to represent inputs and
outputs and thankfully humans have
standardized a lot of this they don't
always dis agree and this is why we have
different file formats for Apple numbers
and Microsoft Excel and Google
spreadsheets and sort of stupid
incompatibilities like that but
generally speaking humans have
standardized how we represent the inputs
and outputs to and from problems but
let's now focus on this black box so to
speak in the middle this abstraction so
abstraction is technically a term that
you'll see all over the place in
computer science and really problem
solving that just refers to the
simplification of something so that you
don't focus on the lower level
implementation details you really just
focus on the high level goals or the
process itself uh Therefore your car if
youve uh if you have a license and have
driven or have been in a car a car so
far as you're concerned is probably an
abstraction most of us if you're like me
probably don't really know or care how
the engine works and all the parts that
are moving to you it's just a way of
getting from point A to point B it's an
abstraction but someone hopefully the
mechanic does know those lower level
implementation details if you had to
understand how a car works every time
you want to go to school or to the store
it's probably going to be a pretty slow
process you just want to think and
operate at this higher level of
abstraction and we're going to do this
all the time when writing code and
solving problems
so what then is in this black box this
abstraction at the moment well generally
it's what a computer scientist would
call an algorithm stepbystep
instructions for solving some problem
now let's consider the implementation
details that is to say how you might
solve certain problems and let's take a
a sort of old school example but in
modern form this icon if you have an
iPhone is of course for your contacts
application and if you've got a whole
bunch of family members or friends or
colleagues in your phone book you have
some kind of contacts pictured here here
and it's alphabetized typically by first
name and last name and odds are you and
I are in the habit if they're not
already a favorite of like clicking on
search and then using autocomplete and
what happens when you start typing
autocomplete well if you type in the
letter H you'll see only presumably
Hagrid Harry Hermione and so forth if
you type in ha that shows you only
Hagrid and Harry and it all happens
super fast so how is that happening well
typically you could just start at the
top and look to the bottom searching for
all the hes or all of the ha but for
larger data sets that's going to get
slow for the Googles of the world that's
going to get really slow and even on our
phones when you have hundreds thousands
of contacts eventually even that kind of
approach that algorithm step by step but
it might be slow so how might we go
about searching for someone in a phone
book like this uh like say uh John
Harvard well here's an old school
incarnation of this and uh odds are you
might not have had occasion to even
physically use this thing nowadays and
in fact this is a bit of a white lie cuz
this is the Yellow Pages which means
this is a book of companies not people
uh but for this is all you can find and
at that it's even hard to find this but
this is the same thing in analog form
physical form so if I wanted to search
for someone like John Harvard how could
I do that well I could start on page one
and I could start searching for page two
page three page four page five little
hard to do physically especially since
no one's used this phone book in a lot
of years but uh is this algorithm
correct Turning Page by Page
very inelegantly is this correct will I
find John Harvard if if he's in here all
right so yes I mean this is a little
stupidly tedious because if there's like
a thousand Pages he might be a few
hundred pages into this but it's correct
at some point I will find him and if
he's on the page I'll be able to call
why because presumably the names are
alphabetized in here and there's no like
cheat sheet on the edge so I have to
search for John Harvard from left to
right searching for H if it's
alphabetized by last name well what
would be marginally better well how
about two pages at a time it's hard to
do with a 20-year-old old phone book
where the pages are kind of uh grown
together but 2 4 6 8 10 12 this
algorithm is this correct all right so
no
why yeah so I'm skipping every other
page so if I don't consider that and I
find myself in like the I section or the
J section well I might accidentally
conclude nope I haven't found John
Harvard yet just because I skipped them
because it was sandwiched between two
pages now I can fix this I think if I do
hit the I section well let me just
double back one page just in case he was
in that last page so it's recoverable
but it's almost twice as fast minus that
that hiccup there but what most of us
would do and what your phones are doing
albeit digitally is they open up roughly
to the middle of the phone book and they
look down and they say oh I'm in roughly
the M section so I'm roughly halfway
through this thousand page phone book
but what do I now know about John
Harvard where is he to my left or to my
right all right so alphabetically he's
presumably to my left and so here I get
can both uh met uh metaphorically and
physically tear the problem in
half you don't need to be impressed it's
really easy down the the spine that way
but uh I know that John Harvard is to
the left here but now I can throw
unnecessarily dramatically half and page
one out of the way and what do I now
know I've gone from a thousand pages to
like 500 I can kind of repeat roughly
the same algorithm go to the half of
this and so this time I went back a
little too far I'm in now the um e
section so what do I know is John
Harvard to my left or to my
right to my right so I can again tear
the problem in half throw this half away
and now I'm really flying I'm toing it
verbally slowly but that went from a
th000 pages to 500 to now 250 and now I
can do it again 125 i' do it again
roughly like 67 and keep doing it again
and again and again until I get left
with hopefully just one single page or
in this case an ad for ironically a
mechanic okay so
what is the implication for our
performance well let's just do this sort
of in the abstract if you will if that
first algorithm were to be plotted just
quickly on a chart without even numbers
here's my x-axis size of problem on the
x-axis so the bigger the problem the
farther out that way time to solve the
problem the tire you go up on the y-
axis the uh more time you're taking to
solve it how would we draw the running
time The amount of time taken to run
that first algorithm well it's going to
be a straight line why cuz if you add
one more page next year because more
people move to Cambridge you're going to
add one more page turn potentially so
one more second one more unit of time so
it's a straight line and we'll abstract
it away as n if there's n pages in the
phone book the slope of this line is
essentially n the second algorithm
wherein I was doing two pages at a time
was twice as fast but it's still a
straight line and in fact let me just
draw some dotted lines here if the phone
book is this big with my first algorithm
it might take this many step this many
units of time this many steps this many
page turns but with that that second
algorithm notice that the intersection
is with much lower on the yellow line
than on the red so n/2 means there's
half as many pages here if n is the
number of pages so indeed that algorithm
the second one is twice as fast minus
the little hiccup that I have to double
back one page but that's not a big deal
if I'm still doing things twice as fast
but the third algorithm looks
fundamentally different it looks like
this logarithms if you recall from high
school or prior if you don't that's fine
too it's just a fundamentally different
function a different shape and notice
that the green line is going up and up
and up but a much slower rate of
increase which means crazy things are
possible if two towns in Massachusetts
like Cambridge and Austin across the
river merge next year for instance in
terms of their phone book their phone
book just got twice as big for the first
algorithm that's going to take me twice
as many steps to go through the second
algorithm almost Twi it's going to take
me 50% more steps to go through two at a
time but the third algorithm that I
ended with tearing things again and
again divid and conquering if you will
in half and in half and in half how many
more steps will my third algorithm take
if Cambridge and Austin merge into a
phone book that's twice as
big just one more step right no big deal
you just take a really big bite out of
the problem once you decide if John
Harvard is to the left or to the right
and so you've made much faster progress
and so this in essence is what your
computer your phone is probably doing
underneath the hood when searching for
Harry or Hermione or Hagrid or anyone
else because it's that much faster
especially when you have large data if
you don't have that many contacts
probably doesn't matter if you search
from top to bottom or more uh more in
the form of this divide and conquer
algorithm but if you're the Googles of
the world or you're analyzing large data
sets indeed this is going to add up
quite quickly so where do we go with
this well we're going to introduce next
something called pseudo code how can I
translate what I did verbally there sort
of intuitively to actual code well this
won't be scratch this won't be C or
python just yet it's just going to be an
english-like syntax and this is how many
programmers would start solving a
problem they don't start typing out code
in C or python or the like they use
English or whatever their human language
is to jot down an outline for their
ideas my first step really was picking
up the phone book my second step was
opening to the middle of the phone book
my third step was somewhat different
look at the page because why my fourth
step was if person I'm looking for is on
the page I then do what never happened
in my example but I call the person so
I'm done else if the person is earlier
in the book alphabetically as John
Harvard was in the case of my H then I
should search to the middle of the left
of the phone book and then I should go
back to step three step three is look at
the page thereby repeating the same
process again and again step nine though
might be else if the person is later in
the book then let's go ahead and open to
the middle of the right half of the book
and then go back to line three else
there's a fourth scenario we should
probably consider lest my search process
freeze or crash or give me one of those
spinning beach balls with a bug
yeah yeah what if John Harvard isn't in
the phone book I'd prefer that my
algorithm my phone not just reboot or
freeze I should handle that with some
kind of catchall else so to speak let's
just quit the program so there's
welldefined behavior for every possible
scenario of the four now let's call out
a few of these Salient terms it turns
out if I highlight in yellow here
there's a pattern to what I've been
doing here these are all of my English
verbs and we're in a moment we're going
to start calling those verbs functions
when you program or write code and you
want the program or the computer to do
something for you some action or verb
we're going to refer to those actions or
verbs as these things called functions
like those here by contrast I've just
highlighted instead my if my El if my
Els if and Els this is going to
represent what we're going to start
calling a conditional a proverbial fork
in the road where you can either go this
way or that way do this thing or this
other thing and you're going to decide
which of those things to do based on
what I've now highlighted here which are
going to be called Boolean Expressions
bull referring to a mathematician last
named bull a Boolean expression is just
a question with a yes no a true false a
one or a zero answer if you will and it
governs whether you do this thing or
this thing or this thing or that the
indentation in this case is important
the fact that I've indented line five
implies by convention in programming
that I should only do line five if the
answer to line four is a yes or true and
same for these other indented lines as
well and the last characteristic here is
this here uh someone called this out
earlier in fact these lines eight and 11
are now highlighted and represent
what what might we call these in code if
you've done that yeah so these are Loops
some kind of cycles that result in my
doing the same thing again and again but
there's a key detail with this algorithm
in pseudo code even though it's telling
me to go back to line three why is this
algorithm event going to stop why do I
not constantly keep looking for John
Harvard Forever by nature of these Loops
telling me to keep going back to line
three good eventually he'll be on the
page or or to your point earlier he
won't be at all and we're out of pages
and so we just quit and that's the key
about going to the left half or the
right half it doesn't matter if you do
the same thing again and again you're
not going to get stuck in a so-called
infinite Loop so long as you keep
dividing the problem and shrinking it
into something small smaller smaller
eventually there's going to be no
problem left to solve so even if you
don't think of yourself as a computer
person even if you've never written code
what you'll find in the coming days is
that these ideas that we've just kind of
harnessed from real life are at your
fingertips already and a lot of the
process of learning to code is yes it's
going to be a bumpy Ro uh some bumps in
the road because you can't quite see the
new syntax in a familiar way but you'll
find that the ideas in fact are going to
be more familiar than you might
otherwise think and so we'll see in a
bit and we'll take a break in a moment
uh to take a breather that you will see
these same ideas in a moment in the
context of scratch an actual programming
language via which we drag and drop
puzzle pieces to make actual code work
we'll see some variant of these ideas
things called arguments and return
values and variables but we'll
ultimately convert it into this somehow
anyone want to wager what this program
will do if fed to your Mac or PC or
phone here's just a massive pattern of
zeros and
ones it will indeed say rather
disappoint ly apparently just hello
world and indeed baked into all of these
zeros and ones are not just the h l l o
but also the verbs the action of
printing something to the screen and
there's other stuff too so that the
program knows how to start and how to
stop a lot of stuff that we won't have
to worry about that whoever designed the
computer or the language did but at the
end of the day you're never going to be
writing these zeros and ones yourselves
though our ancestors Once Upon a Time
did in some form we'll be using a much
higher l level language like this in C
or better yet in just a moment like in
scratch like this and indeed this is why
today we focus with focus on and begin
with scratch this graphical programming
language so we have a way of expressing
ourselves with functions conditionals
loops and more but in a way that doesn't
have stupid parentheses and curly braces
and all these visual distractions in the
way and we'll translate that thereafter
to this lower level language but for now
that was a lot that was definitely a
fire hose let's go ahead and take a
10-minute break feel free to get up or
stay here and we'll resume in a bit with
some actual
code uh so this then is scratch a
graphical programming language from a
friends down the road at mit's media lab
that indeed some of you might have used
in grade score the like for playing and
writing code and the like but you maybe
didn't necessarily think about how some
of these Primitives ultimately worked
and in fact everything you've done if
you've used scratch before and
everything you'll see today is going to
apply to all of the weeks to come as we
explore these things called functions
and loops and conditionals Boolean
expressions and more with scratch
because it's so graphical and animated
can create can you create animations
like this one interactive art and
software more generally but you'll do so
by dragging and dropping puzzle pieces
that only lock together if it makes
logical sense to do so and what you
won't have to deal with in this first
week of class is Curly braces
parentheses all of the weird symbology
that you might recall seeing when we
just wanted to say hello world now this
particular program um riging men was
written by a former cs50 teaching fellow
Andrew bar who's actually now the
general manager of the Cleveland Browns
the American football team and so these
are just some of the programs that some
of your predecessors in the class have
created and you'll see in the remainder
of class here a couple of others as well
and more in the course's first
assignment namely problem set zero so
how do we get there well first a quick
tour of what it is we're going to do
this in scratch is perhaps the simplest
program you can write and even if you've
never seen scratch or any programming
language before can probably guess that
this just says on the screen somehow
hello world but what you don't have to
do is type esoteric commands and weird
syntax those curly braces and
parentheses I keep alluding to you just
drag this yellow puzzle piece you drag
this purple puzzle piece let them
magnetically lock together so to speak
click a button and boom with those same
building blocks and several others can
you make what exactly the sorts of
things that Andrew brought to life as
well so here's what we're about to see
at scratch.mit.edu is a cloud-based
programming environment on MIT servers
you can also download it offline on your
own Mac or PC and it gives you an
interface like this on the left hand
side of the screen you'll see a blocks
pette these puzzle pieces AKA blocks
come in different colors which rather
categorize them so pictured here for
instance in blue are a whole bunch of
motion related blocks so Andrew used a
whole bunch of those to have the singer
and the men moving around on the screen
um in synchronicity with the song that
was playing in the background meanwhile
in the middle of this interface is going
to be the code area and this is where
Andrew and sunu will drag and drop some
of those puzzle pieces and other colors
as well and lock them together to get
your character soon to be invented to do
something on the screen indeed at the
bottom right here will you see
ultimately a Sprite area where a Sprite
is a technical term for like a character
in a video game or a programming
environment like this by default
historically scratch uh is the cat the
mascot if you will for this programming
environment and so here we see by
default just one Sprite selected because
on the top right of the screen is the
stage for that Sprite and you can click
in Click and zoom in to make it full
screen but this is the world in which
Scratch by default the cat will live but
you can change scratch's costume so that
it looks like a singer or a man falling
from the sky or the like or anything
else either creating the art yourself or
importing some of the things that come
with it or elsewhere online so what is
this world that scratch rather lives in
well generally speaking we won't have to
care too much about numbers because
we'll be able to ask questions like
intera active ones like is scratch the
cat or any character otherwise touching
the edge of the screen touching
something else but scratch does exist in
this
two-dimensional uh coordinate system
world so when the cat or any character
is dead center in the middle that would
be XY location 0 comma 0 if you will
meanwhile over here is 240 pixels or
dots all the way to the right so this
would be 240 comma 0 where Y is z
because it's right on that midline so
it's neither up or below
over here to the left of course would be
240 and 0 above the cat would be xal 0
cuz it's right on that vertical midline
and 180 and then down here as you might
guess would be 0 comma netive 180
generally speaking we don't have to care
about those precise pixel coordinates
but it's helpful ultimately if you do
want the cat to move up down left or
right having some sense of direction
according to the x- axis and y AIS as
well can help you express your ideas
ultimately so what might some of those
ideas be well let's do this I'm going to
go ahead and create on
scratch.mit.edu just an empty screen
like this one here and so this is the
exact same interface but now I'm in my
browser uh full screen so that I can
start writing some code and let's get
that cat to say something actually on
the screen now this takes a little bit
of practice but honestly just by
scrolling through these puzzle pieces
can you quickly get a sense of what's
possible not just categorically but
specifically and I'll jump around
because I've done this of course but I'm
going to go to events in yellow first
and I'm going to drag and drop this
first block called when green flag
clicked and I've zoomed in there just to
make it a little more legible and notice
that the shape of this green flag just
so happens to mirror this green flag
here at top next to this red stop sign
of sorts and the green flag is going to
mean go and the red stop sign's going to
mean stop to start or stop our program
next week you're going to be writing a
textual command at your keyboard to do
the exact same idea but for now it's a
button so when green flag clicked what
do I want scratch to do well how about
we have scratch just initially say
something like Hello World which indeed
historically is the first program that
most any programmer might write so
anything related to what the cat looks
like it's doing is actually going to be
under looks here in purple so I'm going
to drag over say hello and you'll notice
something curious and different about
this purple block it says of course say
in purple but then there's this white
oval and some text that by default is
hello cuz MIT just decided that by
default the placeholder will be hello
but anytime you see this white oval it's
an opportunity to provide an input into
the function called say and so here I'm
borrowing terminology from before
problem solving again is all about
inputs producing outputs and in between
there is some algorithm in a moment
we're going to start referring to
algorithms quite frequently as functions
why because it's the implementation of
some algorithm so let me override the
default with hello comma World I'll zoom
out and now if I go to the top right of
the screen and click the green flag
we'll see hopefully my very first
program in code now it wasn't a huge
lift right it only was a matter of
dragging and dropping puzzle pieces but
what has now happened well it turns out
that two things have happened when I the
human clicked on that green flag I
triggered what we're going to start
calling now an event an event is
generally something graphical or
interactive that just happens in a
computer program you and I trigger
events on our phones all day long
whenever you tap or drag or long press
or pinch or any of those gestures in
Vogue nowadays on phones you are
triggering events and people at Apple
and Google and elsewhere have written
code that listen for those events and do
something when that event happens that's
what I just did when green flag is
clicked I want something to happen
namely I want this purple function this
verb this action called say to do
something what do I want it to do I want
it to say what this input is and I'm
going to introduce another vocabulary
term the white ovals here are yes inputs
very generically but in the programmer's
terminology they're called arguments
otherwise known as parameters and that
just means an input to a function that
modifies Its Behavior in some way when I
click stop that's just another event and
that one is just built into scratch
scratch knows that when you click the
green stop sign uh everything should
just stop automatically I don't have to
write code to support that feature so
that's all fine and good hello world but
if I keep doing stop and start and stop
and start it's going to do the same
thing again and again and it's really
not that interesting at the end of the
day maybe gratifying once but it'd be
nice if this were a little more
interactive so it turns out that we can
do that too but we need a different
mental model instead so in this case
here when we think about this function
say in this input hello world this
actually Maps pretty cleanly to this
model earlier that I propose is problem
solving is computer science if you will
the input to the current problem is
going to be in white here hello world
the algorithm is the say algorithm now I
don't know how MIT got it to print out
the little pretty speech bubble on the
screen but they wrote those underlying
low-level implementation details and
they gave me and you a purple function
called say that just does that for you
you and I don't have to reinvent that
wheel the output of SE is another
technical term now called a side effect
a side effect is usually something
visual that happens like as a side
effect of you calling a function and so
the side effect here is that the cat has
this speech bubble magically appear
inside of which is hello world so we
have an input we have an output we have
an algorithm but now we're talking about
these ideas in the context of
programming so now the input is an
argument the algorithm is a function and
the output in this case is a side effect
terminology that you'll just hear more
and more and it'll eventually sink in
but not to worry if the terminology
doesn't come naturally early on so what
more might I do with this let me go back
to scratch here and make this maybe
perhaps more interactive and actually
get the cat to say something a little
more dynamically so instead of hello
world why don't I get it to say hello to
me or to you or anyone else so let me do
this let me go under say uh let me get
rid of this first and you'll notice this
neat trick as soon as you start dragging
on a block if it gets close to it it
kind of goes gray and it can be
magnetically snapped together you don't
have to do it very precisely conversely
if I want to get rid of a puzzle piece I
just drag it anywhere on the left let go
and that deletes it or you can right
click or control click in a little menu
will let you delete it as well well let
me do this instead under sensing which I
know is there because I've done this
before are a whole bunch of things
related to sensing whereby the cat can
kind of feel out its World in some sense
it can do things like ask this question
am I touching the mouse pointer like the
user's cursor am I touching a specific
color that you can override to be
anything you want is the distance to the
mouse pointer some specific value but
for now I'm going to focus this on this
this blue puzzle piece that asks a
question which itself is this white oval
that I can apparently change and then
it's going to wait for a response but
this puzzle piece is a little different
it's a little special it comes with a
freebie it comes with what we're going
to call technically a return value so
some functions don't just do something
on the screen they hand you back so to
speak a value that you can do anything
that you want with nothing happens
immediately unless you do something with
that so-called return value so let me go
ahead and drag this thing over here ask
what's your name and I'll use the
default question that seems a reasonable
place to start I'm not going to override
that default and now let me go ahead and
zoom out let me go back to looks let me
go to say and let me just form the
English sentence I want so let me zoom
in here and type in hello maybe comma
space I could do David but that's that's
obviously not right because I'm asking
for a name and then I'm like in advance
hardcoding my name that's not what I
want I just want hello comma and now let
me zoom out and grab one more say block
Let Me Maybe say here okay I don't want
to say hello hello I I don't want to
just type in my own name CU again then
what's the point of asking the user for
their name but notice this if I go back
to the sensing block this is where that
oval that's blue called answer is useful
this will be the so-called return value
of that function so I'm just going to go
ahead and do this and drag and drop even
though it's not the right size it is the
right shape and so scratch will be smart
about it and grow to fill that puzzle
piece for you let me zoom out now and
now let me click the green flag you'll
see that scratch is indeed prompting me
with the speech bubble what's your name
notice the little text box below the cat
is asking what's your name so I'm going
to type in da a v d and hit enter or I
can click the blue check
enter okay it's a little weird I wanted
him to say hello not just my name so let
me stop let me start it again all right
hello what's your name da a v
enter huh kind of rude uh why is there
this bug like I wanted to say hello
David not just David and and yet twice
it has failed to do so uh
yeah yeah the computer is processing my
directions my actions really quickly and
so it actually is doing it it's just you
and I in the room are just way too slow
to notice that it said hello David it
just seems to have just said David so
all right how can I fix this well here's
where you start to poke around and think
about how you might solve this let me go
back under looks maybe there's a smarter
way to do this maybe I could do okay I
could do this how about instead of just
say hello there's apparently another
puzzle piece where I can time it so I
can maybe slow things down a little bit
so let me do this let me throw away all
of this let me drag a say hello for two
seconds let me drag another say hello
for two seconds let me change the first
one to indeed hello comma and then let
me go back to sensing let me grab that
same answer because I threw it away a
second ago and I'll just change it I
don't even have to delete hello I can
just overwrite it like this so now I
think we'll kind of pump the brakes and
see things more slowly let me stop let
me start da ID enter
hello David okay so it's better like it
seems to be working I think your
hypothesis was right just looks kind of
stupid right like the fact that it's
saying
hello David like we can do better and
like literally every piece of software
on your phone or Mac or PC is better
than that it adds words together in the
user interfaces you and I are familiar
with so let's go a little more fishing
here let me throw away these let me go
back to look and just get the simpler
say I want this to say hello comma name
where name comes from that answer return
value so how can I do this well let me
go under operations which we haven't
been before there's a lot of stuff in
here some of it's mathematically related
adding subtracting and so forth you can
Generate random numbers which might be
useful and if I keep scrolling down
there's this join apple and banana but
that's just placeholder text you can
join one piece of text with another
piece of text by default apple and
banana but let's change it to hello and
my name name so this to wrong size but
right shape so let me let it snap into
place let me go ahead now and do hello
comma and now I think I just want to go
grab that answer return value let me
drag the same oval as before clobber
that is overwrite banana so now I'm kind
of composing functions the output of one
function join is going to be the input
of another function say so let's see
what happens now that they're kind of
stacked on top of each other or nested
so to speak click the Green Arrow a
green flag DAV ID enter hello David all
right that was pretty fast let's just
just do it once more stop start here we
go daavid enter okay right it's not the
most exciting program in the world but
it's more correct it's better design
just because that's what you would kind
of expect the software to do and not be
some kind of lame user interface that's
just inserting random delays to just
make it kind of work like that's a
workaround a hack if you will but
there's some cool things you can do with
scratch and we won't really go down the
rabbit hole of all of the fun and
familyfriendly features that it has but
there is one that's kind of cool here
let me go into the extensions button at
the bottom left of my screen and this
one's kind of cool let me go to text to
speech and you'll notice that this one
requires internet because it's
cloud-based but this just gave me some
new puzzle pieces in a new category text
to speech and these green ones do
exactly what they say so let me do this
let me zoom out again let me keep the
join block and I'm just going to
temporarily toss it over here it's not
going to delete itself cuz I didn't drag
it over to the other side but I'm going
to get rid of the say block in purple
I'm going to do the speak block here in
green and let it snap into place and
then I'm going to drag and drop this
onto the input to speak and now perhaps
a little more adorably let's try this
green flag what's your name d ID enter
and hello
David okay it's a little it's a little
robotic but at least now it has
synthesized speech and I've kind of got
my own like Siri or Google assistant or
Alexa thing going on here now where it's
now recognized whatever text it is and
it's played it well let's make this an
actual cat that doesn't talk in that
weird human voice let me go ahead and
get rid of most of this stuff and let's
get the cat to actually meow like a cat
tends to and let me go under the sounds
block now MIT gives you a few sounds for
free because it's designed around a cap
by default and I'm going to go ahead and
grab this one play sound meow until done
and now and we saw I heard a teaser for
this earlier in the
crowd
it's a little piercing admittedly we can
lower the volume a little bit there but
notice if I want the cat to meow a
second time I'll just click it
again okay and over there too I
hear okay all right so it's kind of cute
now right so it's just meow okay yes
echo echo so it's meowing now every time
I hit the green flag now that's great
but even a kid is probably going to like
would prefer that it just meow perhaps
like again and again without having to
keep hitting the button so well how
might we do this all right well if I
want it to meow multiple times why don't
I just like grab it another time and
another time alternatively you can right
click or control click a puzzle piece
and just duplicate it from a little menu
that drops down so here we go three
meows all right that's not really a
happy cat it sounds maybe hungry so can
we slow that down well maybe in fact if
I poke around let me go under control
looks like there's a weight block wait 1
second by default and notice scratch
will be pretty accommodating if you just
hover in between blocks it will grow to
fill that too so I could change it to
one or two or anything seconds I'll just
leave it at the default for now one and
now I'll go ahead and do
this okay so cuter and less hungry and
just more friendly but this isn't the
best design it is correct and let's use
that as a term of art correct means the
code does what you want it to do I want
the cat to meow three times slow slly
and it did so iager this is correct but
it's not the best design and this is
where things get more subjective right
like you could write accurate sentences
in an essay for an English class but
otherwise just it's just completely a
mess like your arguments here and there
and you don't say anything wrong but you
don't say it well in the context of code
we can do better than this and copy
paste or repeating yourself again and
again tends to be bad practice why
suppose that you want to change the
weight to two seconds instead of one
it's aditt not a big deal F I click
there I change it to two I click there I
change it to two but what if you Ma five
times 10 times now I have to change the
weight like in five 10 different places
like that's just stupid it's taking
unnecessary human time and you're going
to screw up eventually especially if
your program is getting longer you're
going to miss one of the inputs you're
going to leave the number wrong and
you're that's a bug so just based on
what you've seen already or if you've
programmed before which a few of you
have what's the term of art here that
will solve this how can we design this
better I heard it here here yeah so a
loop a loop some kind of cycle that says
do that again do that again not
infinitely many times necessarily but
some finite number well you can perhaps
see a spoiler on the screen under the
same uh orange control category is a
repeat block and by default it's
proposing 10 but we can change that so
let me do this I'm going to throw away
most of this copy paste as redundant I'm
going to detach this temporarily just to
make room for something else and I'm
going to drag a repeat block over here
and let that snap into place and I'm
going to change it for now just to be
three for consistency and this is the
correct shape even though it's too small
but scratch will accommodate that for us
and now same uh same output but arguably
better designed why because if I want to
change the number of meows I change it
in one place no copy paste messiness if
I want to change the waiting one place I
don't have to change it in multiple
places and not screw up so let me hit
the green
flag all right so nice now it would have
been nice if MIT had just given us a
meow block that just automates all of
this for us let me wager they gave us
the low-level implementation details
they gave us the play sound meow but I
had to implement like a decent number of
blocks just to get a cat to meow again
and again I feel like we should have
gotten that for free from MIT well they
don't have to be the only ones that
invent blocks for us to use you can
write your own functions your own verbs
or actions so how can we do this let's
make our own puzzle piece called now
that uses this code but creates it in
such a way that it's reusable elsewhere
so let me do this under my blocks in
pink here I'm going to go ahead and
click literally make a block now here's
an interface via which I can give the
block a name Meo W will be the name of
this block and I'm just going to go
ahead and quickly click okay that just
gives me a very generic pink puzzle
piece that starts with the word Define
because scratch is asking me to Define
that is implement or create this new
puzzle piece for me well what does it
mean to meow I'm going to claim that it
means to do these two steps to play the
sound meow and then just wait for one
second but what's powerful about this
idea is look at this up top now that
I've made a block it exists in scratch D
MIT didn't need to create this for me I
created it for myself and even you if we
end up sharing code so I can now drag
meow up in here and what's nice about
meow is that itself is yes a function
but it's also an abstraction like never
again do I or even you need to worry or
care about what it means to meow or
implement it I can sort of drag it out
of the way I didn't delete it drag it
out of the way out of sight out of mind
why because my code is now even better
designed in some sense because it's more
readable what is it doing when the green
flag is clicked repeat three times meow
it just says what it means and so it's a
lot easier to read it and it's a lot
easier to think about it especially if
you're using Meow in other uh projects
too now let me go ahead and right hit
click play same thing so it's not really
fundamentally any different but I can
make this custom puzzle piece this own
function of M meow even more powerful
let me kind of rewind a bit and go to my
meow puzzle piece and I am going to
control click or right click on my pink
puzzle piece and I'm going to edit it so
I kind of regret making meow so simple
wouldn't it be nice if meow took an
input AKA an argument that tells meow
how many times to meow then I can get
rid of that Loop and just tell meow how
many meows I actually want so I'm going
to click on another button here called
literally add an input and it's going to
have placeholder here so I'm just going
to put a placeholder there I keep using
n for number which is a go-to in
computer scientist terms um and I'm
going to add some descriptive text just
so that it's a little more
self-explanatory I'm just going to say
meow n times but there's only one oval
times is just going to be explanatory
text and now notice what has happened
now my puzzle piece takes an input AKA
an argument that will tell that function
to meow some number of times but it's
not just going to going to work
magically I need to implement that lower
level detail so let me zoom out I have
to remind myself what this function was
so I'm going to drag it higher up just
so they're on the screen at the same
time I'm going to go ahead now and
temporarily move this over here I'm
going to temporarily detach this over
here why because what I think I want to
do is move my Loop into the function
itself move the play and the weight into
the loop but I don't want to hardcode
three notice that n here is its own oval
I can drag a copy of N and just let it
go there so now I have a new version of
meow that takes an argument in that
tells meow how many times to meow and
now let me again drag this out of sight
out of mind because who cares how I
implemented it once it's implemented
it's sort of done now my program is even
better designed in some sense why
because now it really just says what it
means there's no Loop there's no repeat
no like implementation details when
green flag clicked meow three times and
so functions indeed let you implement
algorithms like they're just code that
do something for you but they're also
themselves abstractions why because once
a function exists it has a name and you
can think about it in that term and you
can use it by its name you don't have to
care or remember how the function itself
was built whether it's by you or even
MIT so again here I'll click the green
flag it's the same
thing so still correct but better and
better designed and so anytime here and
out with scratch or soon C and
eventually python when you find yourself
doing anything resembling copy paste or
again and again grabbing the same code
probably an opportunity to say wait a
minute let me refactor this so to speak
that is rip out the code that seems to
be repeated again and again and put it
in its own function so you can give it a
descriptive name and use and reuse it
any questions just yet on now saying or
these Loops or these functions that
we're using yeah
[Music]
how did I make it so it meows three
times so I originally only had a puzzle
piece called meow and I decided to
improve it so I held down control and I
right clicked or control clicked on the
pink puzzle piece at top left and I
clicked edit and that brought back the
original interface that lets me add some
arguments to the puzzle piece itself and
I clicked add an input on the left here
and then I clicked on add a label over
here so that just lets you customize it
even further all right so we've done
this let's add one of those other
Primitives too to do something
optionally so how about we make the cat
meow only if it's being petted by a
human as by moving the mouse to hover
over the cat like a human would pet a
cat well let me go ahead and throw uh
away the meowing uh for now and let me
simplify it by just using a sound I'm
going to go ahead and do this I'm going
to go ahead and have a control block
that says if because I want to implement
the idea of if the cursor is touching
the Cal
then play sound meow or I could use my
same pink puzzle piece but I'm going to
throw that away and focus only now on
the sounds and I'm going to do this uh
if uh touching Mouse pointer so I need
to sense something about the world and
we saw this earlier so if touching Mouse
pointer so notice this shape here way
too big but it is the right shape so if
I hover just right it'll snap into place
and this now in blue is my Boolean
expression a yes no question true false
uh if is a conditional and what do I
want to do well if the Cat is being uh
is touching the mouse pointer I want to
go ahead and play sound meow until done
so let's do this I'm going to hit green
flag click now nothing's happened yet
because it's a conditional right it's
only supposed to do something if I'm
touching the cat let me move the cursor
over to the cat and and and wait for
it h another bug why is the cat not
meowing even though I very explicitly
said if touch in Mouse pointer meow yeah
in the
middle yeah this is again my computers
are so darn fast like yours I click the
green flag it asked the question am I
touching the mouse pointer well no cuz
my cursor was up there not touching the
cat it's too late the cat's out of the
bag and so we have to instead solve this
some other mean by some other means how
can we fix this how do we fix that sort
of race yeah yeah so why don't we just
keep asking the question until I
eventually am I'm not actually petting
the cat so let me detach this
temporarily let me go under control let
me go under instead of repeat some
finite number of times let's just do it
forever so sometimes Loops that do work
forever are a good thing like the clock
on your phone that's in a loop forever
because you want it to always tell time
and not stop at the end of the day so
sometimes you do want code to Loop
forever as in this case so let me go
ahead and drag and drop it there let me
again click the green flag nothing's
happening yet but notice the program's
still running and so if if I move my
cursor move my cursor move my cursor
and okay so maybe we could add some
waiting but the cat does not want to be
pet in this case but it's indeed
conditional so there we have an
incarnation in scratch of doing
something conditionally now we can make
this really cool really fast if you will
let me stop this version let me go ahead
and do this uh let me go ahead and throw
all of this away let me go into my
little uh extensions Bucket over here
and let me do video sensing since most
uh laptops or phones these days have
cameras and there indeed I am with
Sanders behind me and let me do this um
when video motion and let me get out of
the way when video motion is greater
than some value so 10 is the default
this is just a number that measures how
much motion there is or isn't so small
number is like no motion big number is
lots of motion so I'm going to choose 50
somewhat arbitrarily here so 50 this is
not normal to program off to the side
but I'm now going to say this when video
motion is 50 go ahead and play sound
meow like this so the cat is still in
that world I'm going to stop the program
and rerun it so here we go green flag
and
now here come all right this is a little
creepy the way I'm petting the cat
but
and ah
okay there we go okay so 50 was too big
of a number I have to pet the cat
faster whereas this if I don't
know yeah
so okay so you can make things even more
interactive in this way by just
assembling different puzzle pieces and
honestly there are so many different
puzzle pieces in here we're not going to
even scratch the surface of a lot of
them but they generally just do what
they say and indeed when you see on the
screen here um this pallet of puzzle
pieces really a lot of programming
especially early on when learning a
language is just trying different things
and try and fail and if it doesn't work
quite look for doesn't work quite right
look for an alternative solution there
too as even I just had to do a moment
ago well let's go ahead and use actually
how about another example of something a
predecessor of yours made let me go
ahead and grab a program I opened in
advance here uh called wacka um might we
get a brave volunteer to come up who is
willing to whack a mole with their head
virtually maybe okay let's see how about
in way back you want to come on down all
right come on down and in just a sure
Round of Applause for our
volunteer all
right so here we
have come on down there what's your name
I'm Josh oh actually say it into the
microphone hi I'm Josh
okay nice welcome Josh come on
over all right so same idea here I'll
take the mic back you can you'll have to
stand in front of the camera in just a
moment you're going to have to position
your head in a box that your classmate
from yester year
created and we'll start with beginner
okay so line your head up in the Box in
a moment all right all
[Music]
[Applause]
right
[Music]
nice 12
seconds 5 Seconds notice the score is up
to 18 already pretty
good all right a round of applause for
Josh if you
can so notice how using some fairly
simple Primitives things do get
interesting pretty fast and how was that
implemented well there were probably at
least four Sprites so you're not re
confined to just one cat you can create
more and more Sprites change what they
look like so they actually look like a
mole in this case there's probably some
conditionals in there Some Loops for 30
seconds that's checking if Josh's head's
movement is exceeding some value over
this way or over this way then increment
something called a variable we'll see
those two just like in algebra you might
have X and Y and Z storing values like
numbers so can computer programs have
variables called X or Y or Z or more
descriptively called score as in this
case at top right or another variable
called countdown typically one word in
code but in this case two words that
just store some value so there's
probably some math going on in there
whereby the author of this program just
is incrementing that is adding one in
one every time it detected that uh a
mole had been whacked in this case with
movement so back in the day I myself
actually implemented my very first
program in scratch when I was at a
graduate student actually at MIT um cost
registered at MIT taking a class from
mit's media lab specifically the
lifelong kindergarten Group which is the
group that created scratch itself and
the program I wrote all those years ago
and still rather cling to is a little
something here called Oscar time that I
thought I'd play just a quick excerpt of
my myself here so in this case consider
as the music starts playing how this
program which is much more sophisticated
certainly than the earliest say hello
examples we just did might also be
implemented let me go ahead now and
click the green
flag so some trash is moving presumably
in some kind of loop from the
Top If I'm touching the mouse cursor it
follows
me if I hover over the trash can it
responds if I let
go in some kind of loop Oscar pops out
creates a variable with the current
score and it happens
again pretty easy at first
but I don't need to keep playing this up
on stage in front of everyone so my
score is already now up to some six or
so but in a moment two you'll see that
it's going to escalate so I'm taking
into account some time apparently so
now so more and more Sprites are
suddenly appearing and notice that each
time they're appearing from a different
part of the screen that's an illusion
perhaps do that pick a random number
between X and Y so you can actually pick
some range of values to have the game
constantly changing and indeed I'm going
to go ahead and click stop since i'
spent like 8 hours plus years ago making
this and I can never listen to the song
again not that I should be anyway at
this point in my life but this song is
uh synchronized in with a lot of the
actions that's happening and ultimately
there's just a lot of building blocks
but I didn't sit down and Implement
Oscar time as I called it all at once I
really did take baby steps so to speak
and I figured out well how could I
decompose this Vision I had at the time
to create this game ultimately and how
do I bite off maybe the easiest Parts
first and honestly the first thing I did
was I found this image and I just like
dragged and dropped it into scratch okay
done like lamp post is installed it
doesn't do anything it's not interactive
but I at least set the stage so to speak
for the program then what else might I
have done well let me do this let me go
ahead and open up uh in another editor
here a early incarnation of Oscar Time
by doing this let me go into Oscar time
here let me full screen this and here
you have let me hide the trash for just
a moment is what I might call the second
uh version of my program wherein at the
top right of the stage here I had the
lamp post which I just dragged and
dropped and got going but then I added
an actual Sprite and it has to be a
Sprite if you wanted to do things
interactively the lamp post not a Sprite
it's just an image a costume if you will
for the whole stage itself a backdrop
but this thing is indeed a Sprite
because it needs to respond to code and
events like dragging and dropping so
what might I have done early on with
that code well maybe the first version
would have been something like this
where by my very first version of Oscar
time might have said something like oh
this how about let me control the
program as before or rather events when
the green flag is clicked what do I want
to do well I want to go ahead and
forever do something like this uh
forever so I want the lid to open up if
I touch it so if the cursor gets near
the lid I want the lid to open up and
then if I move away I want it to close
so how can I do that I want an if but I
just don't want one question I really
want two a fork in the road that goes
left or right so to speak and let me
grab this puzzle piece here as I did
long ago so notice it grows to fill
what's the question I want to ask well
under sensing I'm going to go ahead here
and say if this trash can is touching
the mouse pointer what do I want to do
well I want to change what the trash can
looks like and this part I did in
advance of class if you go up here to
costumes this is where all the graphical
stuff happens and you'll see that I
imported a whole bunch of different
costumes that effectively much like a
video when you play them quickly creates
the illusion of movement some animation
but it's really just dot dot dot dot dot
different images showing on the screen
well some of these costumes are called
like Oscar 1 Oscar 2 Oscar 1 is closed
Oscar 2 is open so let's just deal with
those first so if I'm touching the mouse
pointer let me go under how about looks
and we didn't use this before but
there's this block switch costume to
something else I'm going to drag and
drop this inside of the if and notice
it's a little bit indented I'm going to
change it not to Oscar 8 but Oscar 2
otherwise if not touching the mouse
pointer this is the other direction in
the fork and the road let's go ahead and
switch the costume back to what I
described as Oscar 1 so let me run this
program and not much of interest is
happening yet but notice if I move the
cursor up down but how is that working
it's just changing the costume that's
being overlaid on the Sprite so it looks
like interactivity but you're really
just changing the Aesthetics and we
humans are just kind of you know
assuming oh it's opening up well no it's
just changing a costume so here's the
difference the high level abstraction
trash can opening the lower level
implementation detail
costume changing creating that illusion
and if I wanted to look prettier I could
just have many other costumes and go
boom boom boom boom boom to create more
frames per second if you will so I need
to do um one other thing maybe if I
accidentally leave the trash can open
let me make one change here let me make
sure that the very first thing I do when
the green flag is clicked is always
start with the trash can closed because
otherwise you might accidentally leave
it open so this gets me into some
default state so now it's always closed
until I manually hover over it instead
well what might I have done next well if
I wanted to introduce something like the
trash I need a second Sprite and here in
advance I grabb the image already let me
pretend that this never happened let me
drag this away here and now I have
nothing in my code area for this piece
of trash but it is a second Sprite and
all I did was I clicked on the little
cat plus icon here created a second
Sprite I named it trash I added an
costume for it sort of the aesthetic
stuff I did in advance but here I'll do
now the code how do I want to do this
well how about when the green flag is
clicked for the trash can I want the
trash can in parallel to do or I want
the trash the piece of trash to do its
own thing so what I wanted to do is
maybe let's do motion how about and
let's go to a specific coordinate now
there's a lot of options here there's
turning go to a random position go to x
comma y Glide more elegantly there's a
lot of different ways to implement
movement I just wanted to go to a very
specific location first so I'm just
going to go to x comma y first and I'm
going to say x how about will be um uh
let's not hardcode this let's just have
it be well let's do it at zero initially
and then 240 so whoops let's do 0 comma
240 so that this piece of trash always
starts at the top middle of the screen
if you think back to that coordinate
system 0 0 is in the middle 240 is
straight above it all right now after I
do that what do I want to do well how
about I control this thing by forever
falling now how do I make the trash move
we haven't seen this puzzle piece yet
but under motion the very first thing is
called move some number of steps by
default it's 10 but we'll do it more
simply let me go ahead and
move uh oh sorry move is going to move
it uh in whatever Direction it's facing
I only want it to move down so here even
I'm getting confused as to how many
different ways there are to do things
what I think I want to do is this let me
only change my y AIS as follows so
here's another puzzle piece called
change y so again Y is the vertical so
let me just change y by one pixel
downward at a time so Nega one one pixel
at a time so it's kind of slow and I
think now I think that's it let me hit
stop notice that my trash can is still
going to be interactive I haven't
changed or deleted that code I've just
added now code for my trash piece of
trash if I click the green flag notice
that after I enable it let me start that
again I had it hidden for before class
but let me enable it now green flag
notice it starts dead center at xal 0 y
= 240 and it's dropping one pixel at a
time if that seems a little boring we
can change it to negative 10 pixels at a
time and boom it's done so that's how
you might change the speed of a program
but I'm going to leave it more simply as
negative 1 and honestly it would be nice
if it doesn't always start from the top
otherwise this game is not going to be
very interactive I'm literally going to
be grabbing the trash from the same
place every time so why don't I instead
stop this let me go under operators and
let's pick our random number so let me
change the hardcoded the manually
inputed zero and let's make X be
somewhere between zero so in the middle
and all the way over to uh what was it
one oh I got my numbers wrong 240 and my
y will be 180 sorry I got my X and my my
y confused so let me play this again and
now we have a game that's more like
games you might have played growing up
or even now like there's some Randomness
to it so the CPU so to speak is doing
something more interesting let me run it
again now it's a little to the left let
me run it again now it's a little more
to the left again now it's back to the
right so Randomness just makes games
more interesting and this is why when
you play any video game if different
things are happening there's probably
just some Randomness and it's quantized
is just a simple number now I think I
just need one final flourish here if I
may let me go ahead and add this how
about uh events or rather yes events
when green flag is clicked I can do
multiple things within the same Sprite
they don't all have to be attached to
the same one let me go ahead and forever
go ahead and do something else how about
whenever the trash is how about touching
the trash can so forever if let's see I
need a sensing block so how about is
touching uh not the mouse pointer this
time but touching Oscar himself there
now let's see what happens all right so
let's go ahead and click the green flag
now I go down over here and let
go okay that's I kind of want it to go
into the trash can how do I make it go
into the trash can how can we take this
high level idea put trash into the trash
can and make it seem to
disappear logically what could we do
yeah okay so when it touches it let's
have it disappear so I could hide it or
honestly if the game's going to be
ongoing like it was letting me Mo drop
more and more trash let me just have it
go ahead and pick a new random location
so let me do this let me go ahead and
copy this puzzle piece up here and
duplicate and I don't want the whole
thing sorry let me get rid of this let
me just do this let me go back to some
random location at the top so now notice
what happens if I click and drag on it
here it goes and I let go it looks like
it's going into the trash can because it
snaps back up to some random location
now the only thing I'm not doing really
is keeping track of any kind of score
and it turns out if I full screen this
it's not going to be draggable by
default so just as a corner case so to
speak something that you might trip over
otherwise let me go ahead and under uh
let's see uh sensing it turns out I also
need this for the piece of trash there's
this way of setting and scratch a puzzle
a Sprite to be draggable or not
draggable I need to explicitly make it
draggable so that when I do full screen
this thing now it Still Remains
draggable and someone like myself can
play it again and again well how about
we supplement this with one final
flourish why don't we keep track now of
the user score so how about when the
user actually drags the piece of trash
to the trash can let me go under
variables here where in advance I've
already made myself a variable called
score I could have called it X or Y or Z
or ABC but that's not very descriptive
in programming you typically give things
a more descriptive English or some other
language name so I called this one score
so how do I want to do this in my score
well let me go ahead and initially set
this game score to zero at the very top
of one of these Scripts
or one of these programs up here and
then anytime my cursor my piece of trash
is touching Oscar let's not just jump to
the top let's change the score by one up
here so now notice if touching Oscar
change the score that is add one to the
score and then pick a new random
location and now green flag let's do
this slowly here it goes it's the trash
can opens I let go and now notice at the
top left of my program notice the score
is now two notice the score if I do this
again is about to become three and so
here we have building blocks literally
of making this program better and better
and better and so indeed that's how you
generally approach solving any large
program uh any problem with code be it
in scratch or C or python or some other
you take this Vision you might have or
some Vision you've been assigned in a
homework assignment and try to break it
down into these constituent parts and
just pluck off the easy ones first put
the lamp post there first and at least
feel like you're making some progress
then pluck off something like the trash
can and just make it do a little thing
and it doesn't have to be in some same
order here I could have done this in a
million different ways but figure out
what the small pieces are that
ultimately like a few of the problems
we've solved today assemble into a
greater solution there too uh so that
you have now a mental model for these
types of blocks and others let's return
for a moment to this we saw a moment ago
that when I started saying hello David
and nesting those puzzle pieces we had a
whole different Paradigm Al together my
input for that second version of hello
world was to now pass in for instance
what's your name into my function called
ask that gave me not a side effect but
what I called again a return value
called answer by default in scratch and
now notice and recall when I had that
same output become the input to my next
block it looked a little something like
this say so how does this type of block
and this nesting the stacking of blocks
fit into the same mental model well same
idea my input for that part of the story
is now taking in not one input but two
two arguments hello and the answer from
before the function in this case is that
new block called join the output thereof
is hello David which itself became if we
sort of animate this the input to my
final function which indeed was still
say and this is only to say no pun
intended that almost everything that
that you do with these puzzle pieces be
in the context of Oscar time or the mole
whacking or even just something simple
like hello world will ultimately fit
into that relatively simple mental model
there now I thought we'd End by taking a
look at just a couple final examples
these ones two made by some of your
predecessors and for this I thought we
would not write code together but read
it instead and so allow me to open up
one other example here that will show us
a few different versions of a program
that a predecessor made give me just a
moment here and we'll see how we might
build up to something even more
interactive and in just a moment we'll
see something they called Ivy's uh
hardest game focused here on these
particular mechanics so here is version
zero so to speak of this program where
in the goal is to create a game where
you have to like get out of some kind of
Maze and you have to get out in this
case the Harvard Crest from this maze
let me go ahead and just hit play on
this green flag so you can see what what
the first building block for this
program might have been notice that my
hand here is actually on the arrow keys
of my keyboard and it seems that by
moving up down left or right this little
Crest on the screen responds in exactly
that way now let's hypothesize for just
a moment even though we've not done
anything quite like this before how
might this code be implemented how do
you get a Sprite be it a cat or a Crest
to respond to keys on a keyboard might
you think intuitively yeah there could
be something that's sensing what key
you're pressing on yeah there could be
something sensing what key you're
pressing on and if you do it again in a
forever Loop you'll just constantly be
listening for keystrokes and this is how
like every piece of software nowadays
works it's constantly waiting for your
phone to be tapped or something to be
typed on the screen so let me go ahead
and look inside of this existing program
here and there's more going on but we'll
take a quick glance what's actually
going on well up here at top left notice
we just have go to x equals 0 and Y
equals 0 that means put the Harvard
Crest dead center in the middle of the
stage then we have forever two functions
that we made in advance as custom
functions uh listen for keyboard feel
for walls so it's doing two things at
once it's forever listening for the
keyboard up down left right and feeling
for the walls in the sense that if I get
too far to the left I don't want it to
keep moving past that black wall and if
it moves too far to the right I don't
want it to blow through that wall either
so it's going to do two things
constantly listening for keyboard and
feeling for walls so to speak and how
are those implemented well this one's a
bit long but on the left here is listen
for keyboard so this pink puzzle piece
listen for keyboard first checks if the
key up arrow is pressed question mark
Boolean expression in a conditional
change y by one that means move it up
one else if the key down arrow is
pressed then change y by negative one
and similar for left Arrow similar for
right arrow and even though there's not
a loop in this pink function there is
where I'm using it so it's constantly
being asked again and again how about
feeling for walls well over here to the
right it's a little cut off but here you
have if touching left wall change X by
one so if you hit the wall it's too late
you're kind of blowing through it
already so I want to move it wh one
pixel so it's no longer touching that
wall similarly if it's touching the
right wall I want to back it up one
pixel so it's no longer touching that
wall so it's kind of like bouncing off
ever so slightly so that it doesn't slip
through that actual wall and what are
those walls well noce down here it's
just a simple Sprite with a black line
that I've oriented hor vertically
instead of horizontally and that's just
so that I can ask questions of these
other two Sprites now that gives me that
form of interactivity what more can I
now do well what if we make things a
little more interactive here let me go
ahead and see inside version one our
second and let me propose what's going
to happen here well how might we add a
little something like Yale into the mix
well what's Yale going to do when I I
hit the green flag now based on this
code any
hunches here is the code for my Yale
Sprite yeah yeah it's kind of got to be
an adversary by blocking my path
theoretically if I keep writing more
code so why it to goes to the middle of
the screen it points in Direction 90 de
so similarly there's a whole degree
system as well and it forever asks this
if touching the left wall or notice the
green block touching the right wall then
just turn around 180° and in if you
think this through logically that just
means you're bouncing this way and this
way by just flipping yourself around
180° for just this Yale Sprite so if I
go ahead and zoom in on this and click
the green flag I can still move up and
down but Yale is just kind of doing this
all day long back and forth and back and
forth forever nothing bad happens if I
try to go through it but we could add
that certainly to the mix in fact let's
add one final feature before we play
this particular game and let me go ahead
and open up the final version of these
building blocks that adds MIT to the mix
so here's
MIT someone want to explain what this
code does and this is what we're doing
this itself is a skill reading someone
else's code and understanding it is half
of the part of programming besides
writing yeah yeah it's chasing down the
Harvard logo outline so this is
apparently the name of the costume that
this student made Harvard logo outline
outline and apparently it goes to a
random position first but then it
forever points to Har so no matter where
I'm moving it up down left or right MIT
is being a little more strategic than
Yale bouncing back and forth like this
so let's go ahead and play this one in
full screen and here we have a green
flag so if I move up
MIT rather strategically is following me
no matter where I go all right so still
nothing bad happens but and now it's
struggling right it's going up down up
down it's trying to uh follow me even
though I'm not moving so we need some
final flourishes and so I think for this
we need perhaps one final volunteer
after this cake awaits for everyone
outside as is an end of first lecture
cs50 tradition would you like to come up
and be our our vinyl of
volunteer all right and so this will be
the actual version bit written by one of
your predecessors that I'll full screen
here it's going to stitch together all
of these same Primitives in more but add
the notion of score and lives so that
there's actually a goal which in this
case is to move the Harvard Crest to
constantly pursue the character on the
right hand side so that your Sprite
touches that one would you like to
introduce yourself uh hi my name is
Muhammad all right wonderful welcome
aboard and here we come with some
instructions and final flourish if we
want to keep the lights up but perhaps
increase the
music
[Music]
e
you
[Music]
all right this is cs50 and this is week
one wherein we continue programming but
we do it in a different language because
recall last time we focused on this
graphical language called scratch but we
use scratch uh not only because it's
sort of fun and accessible but because
it allows us to explore a lot of these
Concepts here Nam functions and
conditionals Boolean Expressions Loops
variables and more and so indeed even if
today's syntax as we transition to this
new language called C feels a little bit
cryptic maybe a little intimidating at
first and you don't quite see all of the
meaning of the symbols beyond the syntax
itself realized that the ideas are
ultimately going to be the same in fact
as we transition from what was last week
a hello world program that looked a
little something like this this week of
course it's going to now look a little
more cryptic it's going to look a little
something like this and now even if you
can't quite distinguish what all of the
various symbols mean in this code turns
out that at the end of the day it's
indeed going to do what you expect it's
just going to say hello world on the
screen just like we did in scratch so
let's start to apply some terminology to
these to these uh tokens first so what
we're about to see what we're about to
write henceforth we're going to start
calling source code code that you the
human programmer write is just
henceforth called source code doesn't
matter if it's scratch doesn't matter if
it's C doesn't matter if it's python
before
source code is the general term for
really what you and I as human
programmers will ultimately write of
course computers don't understand source
code it turns out computers don't
understand scratch and puzzle pieces per
se or C code like we're about to see
they only understand this which we
called what last week yeah so this is
binary zeros and ones but really it's
just information represented in binary
and in fact the technical term now for
patterns of zeros and ones that a
computer not only understands
understands how to interpret as letters
or numbers or colors or images or more
but knows how to execute as well
henceforth is going to be called machine
code to contrast it with source code so
whereas you and I the humans write
source code it's the computer that
ultimately only understands machine code
and even though we won't get into the
details of exactly what pattern of
symbols means what you'll see that in
this kind of pattern of zeros and ones
there's going to be numbers there's
going to be letters but there's also
going to be instructions because indeed
computers are really good at doing
things addition subtraction moving
things in and out of memory and suffice
it to say that the Macs the PCS the
other computers of the world have just
decided as a society what certain
patterns of zeros and ones mean when it
comes to operations as well so not just
data but instructions but those patterns
are not something we're going to focus
on in a class like this we're going to
focus on the higher level software side
of things simply assuming that we need
to somehow output machine code so it
turns out then that this problem we have
to solve getting from source code to
machine code actually fits into the same
Paradigm as last time but the input in
this case is going to be source code on
the one hand like that's what you and I
ideally will write so that we don't have
to write zeros and ones but we need to
somehow output machine code because
that's what your Macs PCS phones are
actually going to understand well it
turns out there's special programs in
life whose purpose is to do exactly this
conversion convert the source code you
and I write to the machine code that our
phones and computers understand and that
type of program is going to be called a
compiler so indeed today we'll introduce
you to another piece of software and
these come in many forms we'll use a
popular one here that allows you to
convert source code in C to machine code
in uh zeros and ones now you didn't have
to do this with scratch in the world of
scratch it was as simple as clicking the
green flag because essentially MIT did
all of the heavy lifting there figuring
out how to convert these graphical
puzzle pieces to the underlying machine
code but now starting today as we begin
to study programming and computer
science proper now that power moves to
you and it's up to you now to do that
kind of conversion but thankfully the
fact that these compilers exist means
that you and I don't have to program in
machine code like our ancestors Once
Upon a Time did be it virtually or with
physical Punch Cards like pieces of
paper with holes in them you and I get
to focus uh on our keyboard as such but
it's not just going to be a matter today
of like writing code it's going to be a
matter ultimately today onward of good
code as well and this is the kind of
thing that you don't just learn
overnight it takes time it takes
practice just like writing an essay in
any subject might take time and practice
and iteration over time but in a
programming class like cs50 we're going
to Aspire to evaluate the quality of
code along these three axes generally is
it correct first and foremost like does
the code do what it's supposed to do
after all if it doesn't well what was
the point of writing it in the first
place so it sort of goes without saying
that you want code you write to be
correct and it's obviously not always
again anytime you're Mac or PC or phone
has crashed some human somewhere wrote
buggy that is code with mistakes but C
correctness is going to be the first and
foremost goal but then there's a more
subjective goal we'll see in time a
matter of design and we saw a little bit
of this last week when I proposed that
we could design even scratch programs
better maybe by using Loops instead of
just by copying and pasting the same
blocks again and again so design is more
subjective it's more of a a learned art
whereby two people might ultimately
disagree as to which version of a
program is better designed but we'll
give you building blocks and principles
over the coming weeks so that you can
have a better sense for yourself if your
own code is well designed and why is
that valuable well the better design
your code is often the faster it's going
to run the more maintainable it's going
to be by you or colleagues if you're
working with others in the real world so
good design is a good thing it helps you
communicate your ideas just like an
typical English essay and then lastly
we'll talk this week onward about style
and this is really just the Aesthetics
of your code it turns out that computers
often don't care how sloppy your actual
code is um where uh in the world of code
it turns out that you don't really need
to indent things in a beautiful way you
don't need to paginate things like you
might in an essay the computer generally
does not care but the human does the
teaching assistant does you will care
the next day when you're just trying to
understand what your code does so we'll
focus lastly on Style the Aesthetics of
the code that you're writing so where
are we going to write code where are we
going to compile code so for this class
not only with C but the other languages
we use later in the term we're going to
use a free text editor that is program
called Visual Studio code AKA vs code
it's super popular nowadays not just for
C but for C++ and Python and Java and
any number of other languages it's a
text editor in the sense that it lets
you edit text and that all that's all
code is going to be now strictly
speaking you could write code on paper
pencil in fact in high school if you
took a class you might have done that
one or more times as sort of an in-class
exercise you can't run it on paper of
course but you could write it certainly
you could use something like Microsoft
Word or notepad.exe or text edit on the
Mac but none of those programs are
really designed to format the code in
the best way for you nor are they
designed to let you compile and run the
code so VSS code is going to be a tool
via which you can do all that and more
write the code compile the code run the
code so that you all don't have to
wrestle with stupid technical support
headaches at the beginning of the course
by installing this software and that on
your Macs or PCS we'll use a cloud based
version of VSS code at code. cs50. and
that's going to be the exact same tool
and the goal then is by the end of the
semester to sort of uh migrate you off
of that cloud-based environment to your
own Mac and PC so that even if cs50 is
the only CS class you ever take you're
100% equipped to continue writing code
after the class using not something
that's even cs50 specific but a de facto
industry standard at least for some time
so what's this program VSS code going to
look like be it on your Mac PC or
initially in your browser and it's going
to look a little something like this and
there's going to be several different
regions to the screen and picture here
is that very same code I keep proposing
is the simplest program you can write in
C and what are these different regions
of the screen well there's essentially
these four here so first highlighted up
top is going to be one or more tabs
where you're going to actually write
code so much like in Google Docs or
Microsoft Word you can have tabs open
with files similarly in VSS code or
really any programming environment do
generally nowadays have tabs of some
sort and this is going to be a tab
containing a file it seems called
hello.c and that's going to be the very
first file we write in just a moment uh
down here though is going to be an
interface that many of you might not
know this is what's called a terminal
window and a terminal window provides
what's generally called a commandline
interface or CLI and this is in contrast
with a graphical user interface or guey
now you and I every day are using guies
on our phones on our PCS and a guy is
literally graphical so menus and buttons
and icons and you generally use your
finger or a trackpad or a mouse or
something like that to interact with it
but it turns out that many programmers
dare say most programmers at least over
time come to prefer not a guey but a CLI
a command line interface where you
actually do everything somewhat uh
somewhat arcely via keyboard alone why
well it turns out there's just more
features built in to most computers if
you can access them with a keyboard
turns out you can most of us can type
faster than you can point and click and
so that ends up being an efficient gain
over time so in time will you get
comfortable using this terminal window
to do things like compile your code or
make your program as well as run it so
you won't be in the habit initially of
just double clicking icons like we do in
our typical real world you'll do it sort
of the programmer's way but it's not to
the exclusion of adding icons and
clickability and more on the left hand
side of vs code there's going to be a
somewhat familiar file explorer some
kind of hierarchical tree like on your
Mac or PC where you can see all of the
files in your account pictured here for
instance is just hello.c which I'll
create myself in a moment and then far
away on the left is the so-called
activity bar and this is where you just
get a lot of traditional menus and
buttons so VSS code itself gives you
both a guey and a CLI but it's within
the CLI the terminal window the bottom
region of the screen that we're actually
going to type most of our commands and
in general in class I'm going to hide
all of the graphical stuff that's just
not of all that uh that much interest so
with that said let me actually change
over to a live version of vs code and
I've indeed HD in the activity bar I've
indeed hid in the file explorer so what
I have here for visibility sake is a
really big area for writing code and a
really big terminal window at the bottom
you'll see in the terminal window
there's a dollar sign and this doesn't
mean any form of currency this is just
the standard symbol that represents type
commands here so the fact that there's
just a dollar sign in a cursor means
eventually that's where I'm going to
type commands but first i'm going to
actually create some code so how might I
program using vs code be it on my Mac PC
or in this cloud-based environment that
you'll get set up for problem set one go
about writing my first file well perhaps
the easiest way is this literally run
the command code and then the name of
the file you want to create notice that
I deliberately end the file with C in
lowercase notice that I've deliberately
lowercased the whole file name and these
are just conventions you could use a
capital H you kind of could use a
Capital C but just don't do that follow
best practices so that it's consistent
with what most everyone else would do
when I hit enter I just get an empty tab
just like the screenshot a moment ago
and it's in this tab where I can now
write my very first program in C
unfortunately it's not quite as user
friendly as scratch where you drag and
drop a couple of puzzle pieces and boom
it's done so I'm going to do this for
memory but this too will become familiar
to you over time I'm going to include
something called standard io. I'm going
to type int main void and parentheses on
a new line I'm going to insert some
curly braces as we'll call them and then
I'm going to type print F and then some
parentheses and then in quotes hello
comma world then a backslash then a
lowercase n then a close quote and then
a semicolon at the very end of the line
so all I've done is recreate just from
memory that very first program in a
little bit we'll make clear what most of
this does but for now let's just
actually run this thing and just like I
click the green flag last week for the
first time let's actually compile and
run this program if it were your Mac PC
and Google or Microsoft or someone else
had made the software at this point in
the story we'd be double clicking an
icon but we can't do that yet this is
still source code so I'm going to click
back down in my terminal window notice I
have a second dollar sign below the
first which just means it's ready for a
second command and now the command via
which to make this an actual program to
compile it from source code to machine
code is going to be quite simply make
and then the name of the program I want
to make slight subtlety I'm omitting
deliberately. C because the program I
want to make I just want to call hello
so don't write make hello. C just write
make hello and this program make is
essentially our compiler technically
speaking it's a program that automates
the compilation of my program for me but
it is going to see that I've typed the
word hello it's going to automatically
look now for a file on the hard drive
called hello.c and convert it from
source code in C to machine code in
zeros and ones so if I didn't make any
typos
enter nothing seems to happen and that's
a good thing almost always if nothing
gets outputed on the screen like you did
good like you didn't make any mistakes
you didn't get yelled at there's no
error messages so this is actually a
good thing how do I now run this program
well notice I've got a third dollar sign
which just means I'm ready for a third
command and now I'm going to go ahead
and run dot slash hello and this is
admittedly a little weird that you have
to do dot slash but for now just take on
faith that this is how you run a program
called hello in your current folder in
your current directory in this
cloud-based environment all right
crossing my fingers again hitting enter
and voila my very first program in see
hello world and now let me go ahead and
reveal the file explorer that I proposed
exist earlier I'm just going to use a
keyboard shortcut to reveal that and
generally I keep it close because I
don't really need to know constantly
what files are in my account but you'll
see now in the file explorer similar
INSP to a Mac or PC but graphically a
little different here's my file hello.c
it's highlighted because I have that tab
open but now there's a second file here
called just hello that's the name of my
program so if you were on a Mac or PC
you would ideally double click that
thing you can't do that in a command
line environment you have to run it down
here but that's all we've done we've
created a file called hello.c and then
my compiler made the program from that
let me pause here and see if there's any
questions because it's a lot of magical
phrases
yeah yeah so if you're currently
following along uh playing along at home
and you're getting some kind of error
message part of today will be for me to
deliberately induce some of those error
messages for now let me just propose
that if you literally did what I did you
must have made a typo somewhere and
notice that it's indeed standard IO
stdio.h uh maybe you type
studio. okay super common mistake if I
don't if I could call you out um like it
is not studio. it is standard io. so
common but this is exactly
representative of like the kind of
stupid headaches you're going to run
into this week probably for a few weeks
probably honestly for a few years but
you start to see past these sort of
stupid mistakes over time and it just
gets easier and easier because the
computer is going to be so regimented
like you it will only do what you tell
it to do and if you say because it's
verbally sounds like studio. it's not
going to know what the file is so
actually thank you for tripping over
that so early that's super common to
happen yeah have two hello so I why do I
have two hello files so why do I have
two hello files one is the one I created
as the human called hello.c and it's
pictured right here but then when I ran
make hello that process compiled my
source code into machine code so this
second file just called hello is the
file that contains all of those zeros
and ones that the server actually
understands all right so yeah
question if you try clicking on the
Hello file you'll see in this
environment of vs code quote unquote the
file is not displayed in the editor
because it is either binary AKA zeros
and ones or uses an unsupported text
encoding in this case it's binary it's
zeros and ones now you could use
software to see those zeros and ones it
won't be intellectually enlightening to
most any human so VSS code just takes
the choice of not showing it to you at
all so that would be a common mistake
too clicking on a file you don't intend
but the source code is indeed going to
be editable by us all right all right so
I've written this program it seems to
sort of magically work at least with
some effort if you get every single
keystroke right well what is it that's
going on and how is this working well
first of all notice that even without my
highlighting things or choosing buttons
from menus notice that it's already kind
of colorcoded and yet I wasn't
highlighting along the way in sort of
Google doc style changing the color
certainly well it turns out what VSS
code and most programming environments
nowadays do for you automatically is
syntax highlighting so syntax
highlighting is just this feature of
typical text editors nowadays that
analyzes the code that you've typed and
when it notices certain types of
keystrokes things that represent
functions or conditionals or Loops or
variables a lot of the vocab from last
week it just highlights it ever so
differently for you so main for instance
which we'll soon see is in purple here
int and void and include are in red
hello world is in blue my parentheses
are in green this will totally vary by
programmer too in fact if you do want to
change these colors for problem set one
for your own environment you can poke
around vs code settings via the gear
icon you can change a different a change
to a different color theme syntax
highlighting isn't some specific color
scheme like it is in scratch it just
generally is to each human their own
preference but that's all that's
happening here is this notion of syntax
highlighting at the moment well what
more is going on in this code before I
run it but rather write it well it looks
a little something like this if I take
away all of the colors and then just for
discussion sake let me ahead and color
it a little more like scratch recall
that our very first scratch program that
just said hello world on the screen had
a when green flag clicked icon uh puzzle
piece roughly an orange and then a
purple uh sa block beneath it so whereas
this is the C version if we rewind to
last week this was the same program in
scratch but what's happening now is
exactly the same so if you think back to
last week and you've got some function
like the say function in purple that
might take one or more arguments like
inputs that influences what it says on
the screen and then functions recall can
sometimes have side effects right like
the speech bubble appears on the screen
so last week when we used the sa block
and we passed in an argument of hello
world at left we got this visual side
effect on the screen that says now hello
world in the speech bubble and that's
exactly what just happened in VSS code
but much much more textually and let's
look a little closer now at the code
itself let me wave my hand at the
equivalent of the when green flag
clicked part of my code and let's focus
only on the say block in scratch and the
corresponding function in C so if I step
through this and I wanted to convert
what we did last week with the say block
to C I would first use the print
function although that's actually a bit
of a white lie it's actually the print F
function print f means formatted and
it's just a function that allows you to
format text on the screen There Is No Sa
function in C there's a print F function
what MIT did down the road years ago go
was they took what existed historically
as print F and they simplified it for a
broader audience by just calling it
essentially say instead but notice that
now if I want to convert the scratch
code at left to C code at right it's
sort of the same shape so MIT
deliberately used this white oval if
only because it kind of conjures these
uh this idea of having parentheses too
so on the right if I want to pass an
argument or an input to the print F
function I use an open parenthesis and a
CL parenthesis in those parentheses I
then type whatever it is I want to print
on the screen in this case hello comma
world but notice I've deliberately left
some room because you need some extra
keystrokes in the world of C anytime you
type out some text otherwise known as a
string of text to use computer science
jargon you need to quote it in this case
with double quotes double quote at the
left double quote at the right and
notice to I'm going to include some
slightly cryptic symbol here too back
sln which I also typed and said verbally
earlier and then one last nuisance at
the end of this which is a semicolon so
suffice it to say this is why we start
with scratch this drag and drop you're
good to go in a language like C print F
parenthesis double quotes the text you
want backs slash and semicolon at the
end there's just so much syntactic
overhead but at the end of the day it's
just a function and you'll get used to
these sort of nuisances like the
parentheses the quotes the semicolon and
the like but things can very easily go
wrong and it's very easy to make
mistakes even with lines of code like
this so let me do this let me go back to
vs code where I have the exact same code
notice that on line five is exactly that
line of code so this is the equivalent
of the sa block and let's consider what
mistakes I may make early on or even now
20 years later after learning this that
are quite common um in general suppose I
forget the semicolon there so easy to do
you will do this eventually let's see
what happens now when I go back to my
terminal window and try to compile my
code again just to keep things tidy I'm
going to clear my screen but that's just
for lecture sake so that we can focus
only on the most recent command but I'm
going to go ahead now and rerun make
Hello this will ensure that my program
is recompiled and this is a manual
process I changed my code the zeros and
ones on the hard drive have not changed
I need to recompile it to Output the
latest machine code so here we go I'm
going to hit enter crossing my fingers
as before but again I remove the
semicolon by
accident oh my God there's like more
lines of Errors now than there are of
actual code and this too takes them
getting used to um the programs we're
using were not necessarily written with
the least comfortable audience in mind
but really professional programmers back
in the day but through practice and
through experience and through mistakes
you'll start to notice patterns here too
so here's what I typed make hello after
the dollar sign prompt now I get yelled
at with as follows hello.c colon
529 well what's that referring to I've
screwed up somewhere on line five on the
29th character on that line generally
the specific character is not that
useful unless you actually want to count
it out but line five is a good clue why
it means I screwed up somewhere on line
five here all right well what is the
error expected a semicolon after
expression and this error is actually
pretty obvious now that I see it and I
realize oh wait a minute all right
here's my line of code here in sort of
asky art so to speak textual uh text
representing Graphics it wants me to put
in green here this semicolon at the end
of that line one error generated built
in so some esoteric stuff there but my
program did not compile when you see an
error like this it means it did not work
so what's the fix well obviously the fix
is to go back up here put the semicolon
there and now if I recompile my code
with make hello I won't clear my screen
just yet just to show you the difference
now it just worked so we're back in
business as before all right let me
pause here though and ask if there's any
questions about what I just did
[Music]
these error messages will become
frequent initially
yeah really good question do you need a
semicolon after every line or just some
it turns out just some uh this is
something you'll learn through practice
through demonstrations and examples
today generally you put a semicolon
after a statement so to speak and this
is the technical term for this line of
code it's a statement and think of it is
it's kind of the code equivalent of like
an English sentence so the semi colon
and code is sort of like a period in
English when you're done with that
particular thought you don't need
semicolons for now anywhere else and
we'll see examples of where else you put
them but it usually is at the end of a
line of code that hasn't that isn't
purely syntactic like uh curly braces
instead other questions on the mistake I
just fixed and created for myself
[Music]
yeah uh correct so line five is where
the error is most likely character 29
means it's sort of 29 characters that
way and then it's actually in this case
giving me a suggestion the compiler
won't always know how to advise me
especially if I've made a real mess of
my code but often it will do its best to
give you the answer like this
yeah ah so how come I first typed code
space hello.c and now I'm typing make
hello two different processes so when I
typed code space hello.c that was
because I wanted to open vs code and
create a new new file called hello.c
it's like going to file new in in a a
Mac or PC thereafter though once the
file exists and is actually open here
and it does autosave you don't need to
hit command s or control s all the time
I can now compile it with make hello
again and again so theoretically I
should never need to type code space
hello.c again unless I want to create a
brand new file called the same thing all
right so what about this other piece of
syntax here let me clear my terminal
window here you can also hit control L
just to throw everything away just to
clean it up aesthetically suppose that I
omit whatever this sequence of symbols
is back sln since I'm not really sure at
first glance why that's even there does
anyone want to conjecture especially if
you've never programmed before what
might happen now if I recompile and
rerun this version of the program I left
the semicolon but I took away the backs
slash
n any
instincts all right well yeah
will the next dollar sign appear
straight after your it will the next
dollar sign will appear right after my
hello world but what makes you think
that back creates a line exactly back
sln is actually a special sequence of
symbols that creates a new line and so
to your point if I recompile this
program make hello enter no syntax error
so it did compile this time so you don't
need the backs slash in you do need the
semicolon but if you don't have the back
sln watch what happens when I do/ hello
this time now indeed I see hello comma
world and then a weird dollar sign and
this is still a prompt I can still type
commands at it like clear and everything
gets cleaned up but it just looks kind
of stupid if I run it again here with
hello you know it's just not very user
friendly it is convention that when
you're done running your program you
should ideally clean things up move the
cursor to the next line for the user and
so the backs slash n is simply the
special symbol otherwise known as an
escape
sequence that c knows means move the
cursor to the next line in other
languages python among them uses the
same symbology as well now if I go back
to the code here and for instance I try
to do this differently like suppose I
don't put the backs slash N I just hit
enter like a normal person would in
Google Docs or Microsoft Word let me go
ahead and try compiling this program and
this you would hope would work right you
would hope this would print out hello
world and then a blank line because I
move the cursor to the next line but no
if I run make hello now and try to
compile that c does not like this now I
get a different error still on line five
this time starting at character 12 uh
error missing terminating double quote
character and then some other esoteric
stuff and then this does not sound good
fatal error this time too many errors
admitted stopping now so I really
screwed up here so why can't I do this
just because like the humans who
designed C decided that if you have a
string of text it must stay on the same
line it can get really long it can soft
wrap that is without you hitting enter
but you can't hit enter to create a new
line if you deliberately want a new line
you have to indeed use this back slash
and Escape character so let me go ahead
and do this let me put it back let me go
back to my terminal window I'll clear
the screen again let me go ahead now and
do make Hello to recompile to that
version do/ hello and voila we're back
in business with uh hello all right so
now let's tease apart some some other
aspects of this code because there's a
lot going on just to get us to say hello
world on the screen for today we're
largely going to ignore this int main
void and these curly braces here we'll
come back to that before long as to why
it's there but for now just think of int
main void and these curly braces here as
really being the C equivalent of when
green flag clicked like why you just
need it there that's how you get your
program going and Maine is indeed going
to be some special function but more on
that another time but why do I have this
line of code here the cor spelling is
indeed standard io.
stdio.h and they're angled brackets this
time so that's a little new there's a
hash and then an include keyword you
know if you don't know what something is
you know there's not really that much
harm in just getting rid of it and see
what happens so let me delete that line
let me go back to my terminal window
clear the screen and then run make hello
again and let's try compiling this
program now without that first line why
I don't understand it so let's see what
happens all right here's yet another
error but let's see how hello. C line
five character 5 so it's pretty early on
error implicitly declaring Library
function printf with type int and then
dot dot dot so implicitly declaring
Library function print F so this is very
cryptic sounding you'll get better at
understanding phrases like these but
apparently I do need the include line
for standard
i.h but why based on this symptom what
might Your Instinct be for what that
first line of code is doing for us in
the first place why intuitively must it
be
there exactly it's like importing a
library so that you can do things like
print things out on the screen now in
scratch you didn't have to do this for
most of the puzzle pieces but you might
recall that partway in through week zero
I went to the extensions button at the
bottom left of the scratch screen and I
imported some extra puzzle pieces for
text to speech that gave us the sort of
creepy uh humanized voice that actually
came out of the cat's mouth well that
was like adding a library code that
someone else wrote in that case it was a
third party then but I gave myself
access to it same here turns out that
you don't really get printf
automatically in C you have to include a
so-called header file that declares that
function to exist now the reason for
this historically is just efficiency
back in the day when computers were
really slower and resource constrained
you don't want to just give yourself
access to the entire kitchen sync of
functionality you only want to include
only the functions you actually care
about nowadays it's sort of a sort of a
a copy paste step because you almost
always want to print something out on
the screen at least when writing
programs like these but these so-called
header files contain enough information
about all of the functions in What's
called the standard IO library and
standard IO just means standard input in
output and that's appropriate right
because printing is pretty basic output
turns out there's other functions for
getting input from the human's keyboard
more on that in a bit but anytime you
want to print something on the screen
and see you indeed need to include this
header file at the top of your code and
that's going to essentially inform the
compiler hey compiler I want to use
functionality from the standard IO
Library including printf in this case
and if you omit the header file by
accident it's just not going to work
because it doesn't know what print f is
it's sort of some unrecognized symbol in
that case all right questions then about
this line of
code this line of code here or what
these header files
are all right you might wonder well how
do you know what functions exist how do
you know what files you might indeed
want to include well it turns out that c
is a many-year old language and it has
ample documentation a caveat is that its
documentation isn't necessarily all that
userfriendly but what we have for the
course is a simplified version of the
official documentation for C at this URL
here manual. cs50. so in the world of c
and other languages too there are what
are called manual pages and these are
just like text-based documentation that
honestly is typically written in a voice
that you kind of have to be an
experienced programmer to understand
some of it so what we've done it this
version of the same documentation is
we've imported all of the original
official documentation but we've added
sort of less comfortable translations in
English for a lot of the functionality
that you might use in class just to help
onboard you so at the end of the day you
don't need this documentation long term
but just to get started we'll translate
it into terminology uh that you might
appreciate from a teaching assistant for
instance as opposed to the original
author of these documents and so for
instance if you were interested in
reading up on what functions exist in
the standard io. um header file well you
could go to a URL like this or you could
search for it at manual. cs50. that
would show you a list of all of the
available functions in that library and
print F indeed would be one of them and
then you could click further on that
reaching a URL like this that's just
going to give you all of the
documentation for how to use print def
it turns out you can do even more than
it uh than just printing out hello world
and we'll scratch the surface of that
today but it turns out that the
documentation will always be your
authoritative Source ultimately for
questions like what can I do and how can
I do it meanwhile it turns out that cs50
has its own library in A Accessible via
header file called cs50.h it turns out
in C that output is actually pretty easy
relatively speaking once you get used to
all the curly braces parentheses quote
marks and the like but input is a little
more difficult and if you have
programmed before input's not that hard
to do in Python it's not that hard to do
in Java it's more difficult to do in C
and we'll see why in a couple of weeks
but for the first couple of weeks of the
class we actually provide you with some
training wheels of sorts whereby we have
a number of functions that are declared
in this file cs50.h it lives its
documentation at a URL like this this
and in a moment we'll use a few of these
you'll see that cs50 provides you with
some functions like get Char forget a
single character from the user's
keyboard uh get int to get an integer
from the user's keyboard uh get string
to get a sequence of text from the
user's keyboard and a bunch of others as
well so let's actually use some of these
functions how about by revisiting really
the second program we wrote in scratch
last time which adds some input to the
output so first version of scratch was
just hello world said the same thing
every time you click the green flag
version two recall though did this it
asked the user what's your name and then
that somehow gave it back a a return
variable return value we called it and
we then joined hello in that name to say
something a little more interesting on
the screen so what did that model look
like same thing as before we've got a
function in the Middle where function is
like the code implementation of our
algorithm that takes in one or more
arguments like what is it you want to uh
say on the the screen ultimately and
return value in this case is going to be
actually a value that comes back so in
the case of getting input we can
consider this ask block again like last
week the input to it is whatever words
of English you want to ask the user and
then it returns a value and this was
called by default in mit's World answer
that we'll see and see you can call
these return values anything you want
ultimately in variables but this is
different from a side effect a side
effect is just something visual often
that happens on the screen like the
speech bubble or hello world a return
value is actually a value you get back
from a function that you can use or
reuse so how do we convert this scratch
block from last week to C code this week
well if you want to ask the user for
something like their name you can do
this you use a cs50 function called get
string and you use the parentheses to
represent here comes the inputs there
too you can then put the sentence you
want to ask the user quote unquote
what's your name but you do indeed need
the quotes literally in C so I'll go
ahead and add those as well well subtle
but I've deliberately included a space
after the question mark but before the
double quote just so that the cursor
moves one step over because in this case
we're not going to get a special speech
box like we did in scratch it's just
going to leave the cursor where it is so
we'll see that aesthetically this just
moves the blinking cursor one space
after the sentence on the screen all
right but the catch is with scratch we
just automatically got back the answer
from the user in a special variable
called answer in C you're going to have
to be a little more specific in C if you
want to get back a return value from a
function like get string you have to use
an equal sign and then the name of a
variable on the left the choice of
variables is up to you I could have
called this anything X YZ I'm going to
more descriptively call it answer for
parody with what MIT did with scratch
but notice that this doesn't represent
equality per se this is assignment in
this case so in C when you use a single
equal sign that means means copy the
value on the right over to the value on
the left from right to left so what does
this do for us well if get string is a
function that prompts the user with
quote unquote what's your name and it
has I claim a return value that means it
kind of hands me back some value but
it's up to me in C to do something with
that value so if I want to copy that
value into a variable that I can use and
reuse I use an equal sign and I invent
on the left hand side of that equal sign
any variable name I want there's certain
rules certain conventions but generally
if you use a single word with all
lowercase you're in good shape but C is
a little more pedantic than that and
those of you who have have programmed
before might not be used to this for
instance in Python which is a world
we'll get to in a few weeks you also
have to tell see what type of value
you're storing so if I do want a string
of text from the user so not an integer
not a single character I want a whole
string of text like a phrase a sentence
a name in this this case I have to tell
C that this variable is of type string
so it's a little wordy but you get used
to it and you just have to be precise
you're informing the computer what type
of value is going in this
variable all right it's so close to
being correct but I have omitted
something that's annoyingly important
still what's missing still yeah so
semicolon this is a statement this is
like a a a full thought if you will in
code I do need to end It ultimately with
the semicolon at the end there all right
so this was more of a mouthful but let's
try using this in now my code let me go
back to vs code where I have version
zero of my code here let me go ahead and
include one other file at the top of
hello.c namely include cs50.h so that I
have access now to get string and
anything else I might want now let me go
ahead and add a line of cod here inside
of these curly braces and let me go
ahead and do this string answer equals
get string quote unquote what's your
name question mark I'm going to add an
extra space before the double quote I'm
going to indeed end my thought with a
semicolon and now let me deliberately
make a mistake just to make a point here
let me now try changing hello world to
hello comma answer all right now perhaps
even though this is some new lines of
code you can see where I've aired
already but let me try making this
program now so far so good so no error
messages so that's a good thing let me
go ahead and run /hello and you'll see
the prompt what's your name question
mark and notice the cursor indeed one
space to the right just because I
thought it would look prettier to put a
little Blank Space there as opposed to
leaving it right after the question mark
let me type my name but even if you've
never programmed before I have screwed
up here what are we going to see on the
screen when I hit
enter yeah hello answer most likely why
cuz the computer is going to take me
literally and if I say quote unquote
hello answer that is the string of text
followed by a new line that's going to
be outputed to the screen so we need
some way of actually plugging answer
into this line of code it's not quite as
simple as scratch where you could just
grab like a second say block and drag
and drop the variable there we actually
need a new syntax and it's going to look
weird at first but it is everywhere in
software nowadays especially in the
world of c and certain other languages
so let me go ahead and propose that I
solve it as follows well back when we
did this in scratch remember that the
most elegant solution was this here we
used the say block still which is going
to be analogous to print F today but I
use the join puzzle piece in scratch to
combine hello comma space and then the
name of the human so how do we translate
this code to C well it's going to look a
little different now I'm going to start
with print f with some parth C's and a
semicolon representing the say block but
how do I now do this joining this is
where the puzzle pieces don't quite
translate perfectly this would be the
way to do this you put hello comma and
then a placeholder so this is what's
known as a format code in C specifically
for printf and it just means this is a
placeholder for a string again a string
is just text so this means hey computer
print out literally hello comma space
and then not literally percent s percent
s is uh treated specially to mean plug
in some value here all right so what
else do I still need well this is still
some text so I'm still going going to
surround the whole thing with double
quotes I'm still going to include my
back sln just to keep things tidy and
move the cursor to the next line so the
last step here in C is to somehow join
the answer with that word hello and the
way you do this is with printf passing
it not one argument which is what I keep
doing I keep passing it one string of
text quote unquote I'm going to now add
a comma and then the name of the value
that I want want printf to go back and
plug into that percent s and printf is
just smart about this if you have 1% s
and one additional argument after a
comma it just does from right to left it
plugs it in if you have two percent S's
and two variables after the comma that's
okay too if you separate them with
commas it'll plug the first into the
first percent s and the second variable
into the second percent s so it's just
left to right order of operations it's
not as pretty or as uh simple as this
but this is how it's done in C all right
let me pause because this is a lot of
symbology any questions on this
technique here
[Music]
yeah yeah really good question why did I
exclude the backslash n a moment ago
really just my sense of Aesthetics if
you will No Good Reason beyond that so
if I look back at my code you quite
rightly noticed that I didn't have a
backslash in there that's just because
for whatever sense of style that I have
I wanted the name to be typed right
after the question I totally could have
added a back sln there instead of a
space that would have just allowed me to
type down here totally fine just wanted
to show you something different good
good catch
yeah can I show an example with 2% s's
surely so let me uh in vs code do this
let me clear my terminal window to clean
things up and let me do this instead of
calling the variable answer all over the
place let me call it uh first and I'll
ask two questions what's your first name
and now let me do string last equals get
string quot whoops capitalization
matters so let me fix my capital S there
quote unquote what's your last name
question mark semicolon and now we'll
plug in one percent s and a second
percent s and now I'm going to plug in
first first and last last coincidentally
and now I'm going to go back to the
terminal window make hello crossing my
fingers
all good/ hello here's my first question
David here's my second question me and
again hello David Ma so it just inserts
them left to right all I was doing for
parody with scratch though and let me go
ahead and undo this again I'll go back
to answer like this I'll go back to just
asking for the person's name I'm going
to delete mention of last I'm going to
delete mention of the second perc s and
now if I recompile this simpler
version I did screw up didn't intend it
what did I do
wrong yeah so just newbie mistakes so I
changed my variable back to answer just
to be consistent with week zero but I
didn't change it here so I have an use
of Undeclared identifier first it's
Undeclared in the sense that I declared
answer align prior I didn't declare
first so indeed intuitively I want to
just change that to that let me now do
make hello again /hello type in just my
first name this time and there it is
hello David questions on this then
syntax with print F
yeah uh the placeholder I'll zoom in is
just a single percent and then an S so
inside of my string here is percent s
and then I have a comma outside the
quotes and then the name of the variable
whose value I want to plug in for that
percent s and now notice there's
technically two commas in side of these
parentheses on line seven and yet I
claim that printf at the moment is only
taking in two
arguments why is there then two commas
but only two arguments if there were two
commas you would think there would be
three arguments
right exactly the comma in between the
quotes is just an English thing it's
separating the hello from the name so
that's why indeed it's not only in
quotes that that's also why programs
like VSS code tend to syntax highlight
it a little differently just so that it
sort of jumps out as different to you
even though in this case it's a little
subtle a light blue versus white but
indeed it's trying its best other
questions now on this placeholder
yeah ah good question if I wanted to add
an exclamation point after the name
would I have to add another placeholder
and so forth I could actually do that
much more simply I can just put the
exclamation point right after the
percent sign I don't need an additional
placeholder per se if I zoom out now and
run make hello again/ hello and type in
just my name no exclamation point now
you'll see more excitedly hello comma
David So print f is smart it will figure
out where the percent s is and then go
and replace it now let me propose that a
common thing in programming is that as
soon as we make a decision as to how to
design something we often paint
ourselves into a corner and sort of
regret a decision can anyone think of a
problem that arises from using percent S
as a
placeholder in this string to print F
what could go wrong if we're using
percent in this special
way yeah if you literally want to say
for whatever weird reason percent s on
the screen or honestly even just a
single percent it turns out that a
percent sign is treated specially inside
of of print F strings so what's the
solution here there's different uh
patterns of solutions to problems like
these but suppose you wanted to say uh I
got 100% for instance let me let me go
ahead and change this completely so I
got 100% on your test or whatever all
right let me go ahead and run make hello
enter all right so invalid conversion
specifier I mean I have no idea what
this means but it's underlining the
percent sign is problematic well it
turns out that humans years ago decided
all right damn it we already Ed percent
well 2% signs will mean 1% literally so
now if I rerun make hello aha hello I
got 100% so there's going to be things
like that honestly that you have to ask
someone you have to Google you have to
look it up in the documentation but
there's always a solution to those kinds
of problems and thankfully they don't
come up all that often yeah oh just
poting other questions
[Music]
yeah if you have multiple variables it
is in the Left Right order so print F
will analyze the first string of text
that you pass in between quotes and
whatever the first percent is the next
the first variable that's passed in
after a comma gets plugged in there and
then the second gets plugged into the
second third and to the third and so
forth so it's just based on left to
right
yeah it's just a placeholder it's called
a format code and it just means
colloquially plug in some value here and
printf the like the humans who wrote
printf decades ago decided to treat
percent s special why just because they
needed some placeholder they decided
that eh no one's ever going to really
want to type percent s and if they do
they can just do percent percent s so
they decided to implement printf in such
a way that they have code that look
analyzes whatever text comes in looks
for percent s and then somehow plugs in
the subsequent values into that
placeholder and just this H question
[Music]
sorry ah so what if you wanted to do
single characters like initials like DM
or djm for first middle last absolutely
and that too is a perfect segue from the
two of you to what in general are going
to be called data types in C so it turns
out in C there's not only strings as
text and we'll see in more detail in
over the next couple of weeks what a
string really is underneath the hood but
strings of text are not the only thing
that programs can output they can indeed
output single characters as for initials
they can output integers as well turns
out that printf has different format
codes for all sorts of different data
types and just some of the data types
we'll see in the coming weeks will be
this list here which you'll notice it
almost perfectly lines up with the cs50
functions that I rattled off earlier
like get Char get int get string the
reason we called those functions that is
because each of them is designed to
return to you a different type of value
we've used get string already in this
example here we'll soon see get in and
we'll see opportunities to use others
but these indeed are the menu of
available data types plus others dot dot
dot that you can use when writing a
program in C the onus therefore is on
you to decide in advance do I want to
store an INT in this variable or a
string or heck when writing fancier code
an image or a sound or a video even
those can all be different data types
dot dot dot but for now we'll focus
really on just these Primitives that was
a lot let's go ahead and take a 5minute
break here no cookies yet but in 5
minutes we'll come back dive into more
detail and our second break today we'll
have
cookies all right we are back and so if
you have been playing along at home but
hitting some bumps in the road that's
totally normal and indeed the goals of
lecture generally will be to give you a
sense uh conceptually of where we'll be
going during the course of the week but
it's indeed through the Hands-On labs
and problem sets that you'll really have
an opportunity at your own pace to work
through uh some of those same bumps in
the road but for today let me give you a
few more building blocks and these two
will translate from scratch initially
namely like conditionals like how now
and see after knowing now how we can use
functions at least uh get string and
print F and we can use variables like
the string I created earlier how can I
now add to the mix things like
decisionmaking and conditionals at that
well with conditionals in scratch we had
this kind of syntax on the left here in
scratch is how you might Express if two
variables X and Y have this relationship
if x is less than y then say on the
screen X is less than y well let me
translate that to the right now in C
code so in C the corresponding code is
going to look like this assuming X and Y
already exist more on that later and
notice a pattern we're going to see
again and again there is going to be
parentheses around the X and less than y
so parentheses around the Boolean
expression recall the Boolean expression
is the true false the yes no answer that
a question that you're trying to ask in
order to decide whether or not to do
something so you use parentheses there
so similar in functions where we Ed
parentheses for printf and parentheses
for get string and this is just a weird
inconsistency stylistically when using
the keyword if you should as a matter of
better best practice put a space after
the word if when using a function like
print F or get string you shouldn't both
will work but you'll find that these are
conventions stylistically that most
people adhere to so space when using an
if here all right now inside of the
curly braces is where the actual code
goes that you want to execute
conditionally so if you want to print
out X is less than y only if x is
actually less than y in C you use this
open curly brace which up until now
you've probably rarely used on your
keyboard and the Clos curly brace down
here and those are kind of hugging if
you will the one or more lines of code
underneath the if very similar in spirit
to how the orange block here kind of
hugs the purple puzzle piece here so
there's no Graphics in C it's all text
so you can think of those curly braces
as really representing the same idea as
a side note if you only have one line of
code inside of the if condition if you
will you strictly speaking don't need
the curly braces but as a matter of good
style do include them it will make more
obvious what your intent is how about in
scratch if you wanted to express this
two ways in the road that you might go
left or right so to speak well if x is
less than y I want to say x is less than
y else I want want to say the opposite X
is not less than y in this case so I'm
making a decision based on that Boolean
expression in C it's almost the same but
you're adding to the mix the keyword Els
so MIT borrowed for scratch the same
keyword there and a second pair of curly
braces open and close respectively and
you might guess now what goes inside of
those well you print out X's less than y
or you print out X's not less than y all
right what if there's a three-way fork
in the road in scratch this actually
gets a little unwieldy graphically if
you will but notice that in scratch this
is how we could express if x is less
than y say x is less than y else if x is
greater than y say x is greater than y
else if x equals y then say x is equal
to Y now minor inconsistency here just a
little bit ago I claimed in C that a
equal sign represents what
operation assignment from right to left
left in so far as scratch is really
meant for kids and they didn't really
want to get into the weeds of this kind
of uh semantic equal sign in scratch
means equality however we're going to
need to fix this in C in just a moment
in c equal sign means assignment right
to left in scratch it literally means
what you would expect all right let's
translate this code then to C on the
right this code would correspond really
to this and you can perhaps see somewhat
goofy what the solution was not unlike
the percent percent solution earlier
when hum painted themselves into one
other corner you say if you say else if
and you say else if and how did we
resolve the use of a single equal sign
already in C when you want to repr when
you want to express equality is the
thing on the left equal to the thing on
the right you literally use two equal
signs right next to each other no space
in between them but now this code would
be correct on both the left and the
right whether you're doing this in
scratch or C respectively but now we can
kind of nitpick our code specifically
the the design thereof logically can
anyone critique the design of this code
either in scratch or C like I feel like
we could do better how about in
back perfect logically it's got to be
the case that X is less than y or X is
greater than y or by conclusion it's got
to be equal to Y so why are you wasting
my time or the computer's time asking a
third question you don't need to ask
this final else if because logically as
you knowe it should go without saying so
it's a minor tweak like you're doing
extra work potentially in cases where x
equals y so we can just refine that and
just like in scratch you could just use
an else block similarly in C could we
simplify this code to just an else a
sort of catchall logically that just
handles the reality that of course
that's going to be the final situation
instead all right so we have this
ability now to express conditionals with
Boolean expressions let's actually do
something with this next here so let me
go back to vs code I've closed hello.c
and I want to create a second file for
the sake of some demos now recall that
you can create new files by typing code
space and then the name of the file you
want to create uh for instance I might
do compare. c I want to write a program
that's going to start comparing some
values for demonstration sake but before
I do that let me just show you by
opening the file explorer at right this
is similar in spirit to a Mac or PC like
you can go up here and click on an icon
and you can click on the plus icon and
you'll get a blue box and I can type in
compare. C and I can just manually
create it that way notice that opens the
tab even without my having typed code so
again on the left you have a guey a
graphical user interface albeit a
simplistic one on the right and at the
bottom here you have a command line
interface but they're one and the same
what's nice though is that if I close
this file accidentally intentionally
whatnot I can reopen it without creating
a new one by just running that same
command code space compare. c so code is
a vs code thing it's just a userfriendly
shortcut but it's just creating a file
or opening an existing file like that
I'm going to hide the file explorer just
to make more room for code here and
let's go ahead and do this let's write a
program that compares two values that
the human inputs but not strings this
time let's use some actual integers all
right I'm going to go ahead and include
the cs-50 librar header file at top
cs50.h I'm going to also include
standard io. why one gives me
userfriendly input via get string get
int and so forth one gives me user
friendly output via printf in the case
of standard i.h now I'm just going to
kind of blindly type this line of code
which we'll come back to in future weeks
but for now that's analogous to the when
green flag clicked code in scratch and
now let's go ahead and do this let me go
ahead and get an INT from the user and
ask the user what's X question mark I'm
not going to bother with a new line I
want to keep it all in one line just for
Aesthetics sake but when I get back an
INT just like I get back a string I get
back a return value so if I want to
store the result of get int somewhere I
had better put it in a variable and I
can call the variable anything I want
previously I used answer or first or
last now I'm going to use x but there's
still two things left to do here
logically even though we haven't
technically done this yet what do I
still need to
do so I need the semicolon at the
end and the in at the beginning you the
programmer starting today kind of need
to decide what you're going to be
storing in your variables and you just
need to tell the computer that so that
it knows now as a teaser for languages
like python more modern languages turns
out humans realize well gee this is
stupid like why can't the computer just
figure out that I'm putting an INT there
why do I have to tell it proactively so
in some languages nowadays like python
we'll get rid of some of this syntax
we'll get rid of the semicolons but for
now we're looking at really the origins
of how this all worked all right so I've
done this one line ending with semicolon
let me do one other and let me get a
second int asking the user what's why
question mark so almost identical but
different responses from the user
hopefully and let me just ask simply if
x is less than y in parentheses then
some curly braces let me go ahead and
print out quote unquote X is less than y
back sln and now just as a side note I I
seem to be typing kind of fast some of
that is because vs code is helping me
let me go back to this
first line with the if hit enter and now
I'm only on my keyboard going to type
the open curly brace this is a feature
of many text editors nowadays it
finishes part of your thought why just
to save yourself a keystroke to make
sure you don't accidentally forget the
closing one so you'll notice sometimes
that things are happening that you
didn't type it's just vs code or future
programs you use trying to be helpful
for you I'll go ahead and manually type
out now printf uh X is less than y back
slend close quote semicolon so let me go
ahead now and try to run this and we'll
see let's see so make not hello but make
compare because this file is called
compare. C hitting enter okay no output
is good because it means I haven't
messed up let me do dot SL compare
instead of/ hello enter what's X how
about one what's Y how about two x is
less than y well let's try it again and
here I'll save you some keystrokes too
let me clear my screen instead of
constantly typing dot slash this and Dot
slash that you can also use your
keyboard's arrow keys in vs code to
scroll back through time so if I hit up
once there's the last command I wrote If
I write uh do it up twice there's the
second to last command I wrote so
sometimes if you see me doing things
fast it's just because I'm kind of
cheating and going through my history
like that all right let me go ahead
though and
rerun compare enter let's reverse it
this time two for x one for y and now of
course there's no no output all right
well that's logically to be expected
because we didn't have an else here so
let's add that else now let's open my
curly braces letting vs code do one of
them for me print F quote unquote X is
not less than y back sln semicolon let
me go ahead and try this again/ compare
enter again two for x one for y and we
should see
huh what did I do wrong why am I not
seeing any else output
yeah exactly you got to get into the
Habit after you change your code of
recompiling it otherwise the zeros and
ones in the server are the old ones
until you manually compile so let's fix
this make compare enter no error
messages that's good do/ compare 2 1 and
now I get back the output so X is not
less than y how about if I go and add in
the third condition well we can do this
either efficiently or inefficiently let
me go ahead head and refine this so else
if x is greater than y let's literally
say x is greater than y and now I could
do X else if x equals equals y but I
think we already claim that that's
unnecessarily inefficient so let's just
have our catchall and here I'm going to
say quote unquote X is equal 2 y back
sln close quote there so I think now
with this code we've handled all three
scenarios let me go ahead and recompile
it properly compare do/ compare and now
1 and 2 x is less than y let me run it
again 2 and One X is greater than y and
lastly one and one and X is equal to Y
so for the most part our code's getting
longer we're up to like 21 lines of code
though some of them are just single
characters on the screen almost
everything else is the same I'm using
the cs50 libraries header file for my
get int function standard i.h for my
print F function and the rest of this is
just now new syntax for conditionals as
well questions then on this C
implementation of just some basic
comparisons like
this any questions
[Music]
yeah good question do the opening
brackets need to be on a separate line
in cs50 yes what you'll see is that as
part of the submission process We
compare your code against a style guide
which is the norm in Industry a company
would have its own sense of style and
how its code should look and there's
generally automated tools within a
company that help uh give feedback on
the code or stylize it as such there are
alternative Styles than what we use in
the class we deliberately keep and ask
that you keep the curly braces on their
own line if only because it rather
resembles like the hugging nature of
scratches blocks and just makes clear
that they're balanced open and closed
however another common Paradigm in some
languages and with some programmers is
to do something like this uh on each of
them so you have the opening curly brace
on the same line as here we do not
recommend this this is invogue in the
JavaScript world and some others um but
ultimately in the real world it's up to
each individual programmer Andor the
company they're working for if
applicable to decide on those
things all right so beyond then these
conditionals what if we want to do
something that's maybe pretty common so
almost every piece of software or
website nowadays that you use has you
like agree to some terms and conditions
by typing like yes or no or just y for
yes and N for no so how could we
Implement some kind of Agreement System
well let me do this let me create a new
program a third one called agree. C so
I'm going to write code agree. C just to
give myself a new tab I'm going to start
as always now include cs50.h let's
include standard i.h and then let me do
my int main void which again for today's
purposes we'll take it face value is
just copy paste and if I just want to
get y or n for instance instead of yes
or no we can just use a simpler variable
here how about just a Char a character A
Single Character so I can use get Char
to ask the user for instance do you
agree question mark but before as before
I need to store this somewhere so I
don't want a string because it's a
single Char I don't want an INT I just
want a Char and it's literally CH h a r
and then I could call this thing
anything I want it's conventional if you
have a simple program with just a single
variable and it's of type Char call it C
if it's an INT call it I if it's a
string call it s for now I'm just going
to keep it simple and call it C and now
I'm going to ask a question so if C
equals equals how about quote unquote
y then let me go ahead and print out uh
agreed back sln as though they agreed to
my terms and conditions uh otherwise
let's see else if the character equals
equals quote unquote n
then let me go ahead and print out uh
say not agreed as though they didn't
quote unquote and let's leave it at that
I think here initially now you'll notice
one curiosity one inconsistency perhaps
does anyone want to call it out though
it's somewhat
subtle I've done something ever so
slightly differently without explaining
it yet do you see it single single yeah
so I've suddenly used single quotation
marks for my single characters and
double quotes for my actual strings of
text this is a necessity in C when
you're dealing with strings like strings
of text like someone's name a sentence a
paragraph anything really more than one
character you typically use uh double
quotes and indeed you must when dealing
with deliberately single characters like
I am here for y or n you must use single
quotes instead why because that makes
sure that the computer knows that it's
indeed a Char and not a string so double
quotes are for Strings single quotes are
for chars so with that said let me go
ahead and zoom out let me go ahead in my
terminal window run make agree enter
seems to work okay so let me go ahead
and do/ agree uh let me go ahead now and
type in y here we go
enter huh uh let me try that again rerun
do/ agree how about no
enter why is it not behaving as I would
have expected uh because you the capital
Y yeah I kind of cheated there and I hit
the caps lock key just as I started
typing in input why because I
deliberately wanted to type in uppercase
instead of lowercase which is kind of
reasonable right it's a little obnoxious
if you force the user to toggle their
caps lock key on or off when you just
need a simple answer that's not the best
user experience or ux but it would work
if I cooperated let me run this again
without caps lock on y lowercase for yes
ah that worked and uh lowercase for no
that work worked but how could I get it
to work for both well how about this let
me go ahead and just add two
possibilities so else if C equals equals
quote unquote capital Y then also do
printf agreed back sln and down here
else if C equals equals uh single quote
uh capital N then go ahead and print out
again not agreed okay this I will claim
now is correct and I'll do make agree
real fast do slash agree and I'll use
Capital it now works I'll use uh Capital
it again works but this is perhaps not
the best design let me hide the terminal
window and pull this up on the screen
all at
once why might this arguably not be the
best design even though it's
correct there's another term of art we
can toss here like something smells kind
of funky about this code this is an
actual term of art like there's code
smell here like something smells a
little off why what do you
[Music]
think yeah there's the same output again
and again I mean I manually typed it but
honestly I might as well have just
copied and pasted most of my original
code to do it again and again for the C
two capital letters so if line 10 and 14
are the same and line 18 and 22 are the
same and then the rest of these if and
Els ifs are almost the same like like
there's some code smell there like it's
not well-designed why because if I want
to change things now just like last week
in scratch I might have to change my
code in multiple places or copy paste is
never a good thing and go God forbid I
want to add support for yes and no as
full words it's really going to get long
so how can we solve this well it turns
out like we can combine some of these
thoughts so let me try to improve the
yeses first it turns out if I delete
that Clause I can actually or things
together in scratch there's a couple
puzzle pieces if you didn't discover
them that literally have the word or and
the word and on them which allow you to
combine Boolean Expressions so that
either this or this is true or this and
this is true in C you can't just say the
word or you instead use two vertical
bars and vertical bars together mean or
logically and so I can say C equals
equals quote unquote capital Y agreed
and now I can get rid of this code down
here and let me go ahead and say
vertical vertical bar twice C equals uh
quote unquote n in all caps and now my
program's like you know roughly a third
uh smaller which is good there's less
redundancy and if I reopen my terminal
window rerun make of agree SL agree now
I can type little y or Big Y and same
thing for lowercase and uppercase n any
questions then on this syntax whereby
now you can combine thoughts and just
kind of tighten things up
and there'll be other such tricks too
yeah a really good question is there not
a function to just ignore the case short
answer there is and we'll see how to do
that in actually just about a week's
time and in other languages there's even
more ways to just canonicalize the
user's input throwing away any space
characters they might have accidentally
hit forcing everything to lower case in
C it's going to be a little more work on
our part to do that but in fact as early
as next week we'll see how we can do
that but for now we're comparing indeed
just these literal values other
[Music]
questions really good question so we are
assuming with this program in all of my
last ones that the human's cooperating
when I asked for their name they typed
in David and not one two three or in
this case they typed in a single
character and not a full word so this is
one of the features often of using a
library so for instance if I run agree
again
and I say something like sure enter it
rejects it alt together why because s e
is a string of characters it's not a
single character now I could just say
something like X which is neither y nor
n of course but it tolerates that
because it's a single character but
built into cs50's library is some
built-in rejections of inputs that's not
expected so if you use get int and the
user types in not the number one or two
but cat C A it will just prompt them
again prompt them again and this is
where too if you were to do this
manually in C you end up writing this
much code just to check for all of these
errors that's why we use these training
wheels for a few weeks just to make the
code more robust but in a few weeks time
we'll take the library away and you'll
see and understand how it's doing all
it's indeed doing all that all right so
how about this let's now transition to
something a little more scratch like
literally uh by creating how about
another program here called meow so
meow. C we won't have any audio
capabilities for this one will just rely
on print and suppose that I wanted to
write a program in C that just simulates
like a cat meowing so I don't need any
user input just yet so I'm just going to
use standard i.h I'm going to do my
usual int main void up here and then I'm
just going to go ahead and do printf
meow back sln and let's have this C meow
three times like last week so I'm going
to do meow meow meow notice as an aside
whenever you highlight the lines you'll
see little dots appear this is just a
visual cue to you to let you figure out
how many spaces you've indented vs code
like a lot of editors will automatically
indent your code for you I've not been
hitting the space bar four times every
time I've not even been hitting tab
however in C the convention is indeed to
indent lines where appropriate by four
spaces so not three not five and these
dots help you see things so that they
just line up as a matter of good style
all right so this program I'm just going
to stipulate right now is indeed going
to work make meow which is kind of cute
and now meow there three times correct
it's meowing three times but of course
this is not well designed it wasn't well
designed in scratch last week why what
should I be doing
differently
yeah
yeah it's a perfect like opportunity for
a loop why because if you wanted to
change maybe the capitalization of these
words you wanted to change the sound to
like woof or a dog or something like
you'd have to change it one two three
places and that's just kind of stupid
right in code you should ideally change
things in one place so how might I do
that well we could introduce a loop yes
but we're going to need another building
block as well that we had in scratch
namely those things called variables so
we're call that a variable like in
algebra x y z whatever can store a value
for you and a variable in scratch might
have looked like this you use this
orange puzzle piece to set a variable of
any name not just X Y or Z but you could
call it something more descriptive like
counter and you can set it equal to some
value in C the way to do this is similar
to to Spirit to some of the syntax we've
seen thus far you start by saying the
name of the variable you want a single
equal sign and then the value you want
to initialize it to copying therefore
from right to left why because the equal
sign denotes again assignment from right
to left this isn't enough though you
might have the intuition already what's
missing probably from this line of code
just to create a variable so we need int
to make sure the computer knows that
this is indeed an INT and then lastly
semicolon as well and that now completes
the thought so a little more annoying
than scratch but we're starting to see
patterns here so not every piece of
syntax will be new all right if you
wanted to increment the counter by one
scratch uses the verb change and they
mean add the value to counter so if I
want to increment an existing variable
called counter this syntax is a little
more interesting it turns out the code
looks like this which almost seems like
a paradox like how can counter equal
counter plus one like that's not how
math works but again a single equal sign
is assignment from right to left so this
is saying take whatever the value of
counter is add one to it and copy that
value from right to left into counter
itself you still need the semicolon but
I claim you do not need to mention the
keyword int when updating an existing
variable so only when you create a
variable in C do you use the word string
or the word int or any of the others
will eventually see only when creating
it or initializing It For the First Time
thereafter if you want to change it it
just exists it's the word you gave it
the computer's smart enough to at least
remember what type it is so this line is
now complete turns out in code as we'll
see it's pretty common to want to add
things together increase increment
Things by One so there's actually
different Syntax for the same idea the
term of art here is syntactic sugar like
there's often in code many ways to do
the same thing even though at the end of
the day they do exactly the same
functionality so for instance if after a
few days of cs50 you find this a little
tedious to keep typing and some program
you can simplify it to just this this is
the syntactic sugar you can use plus
equals and only mention the variable
name once on the left and it just knows
that that means the previous thing it's
just slightly uh more uh more succinct
this to is such a common thing to add
one to a value and it doesn't have to be
one but in this case it is but if it is
indeed one you can further tighten the
code up to just do this counter Plus+ so
anytime in C you see plus plus it means
literally adding one to that particular
variable there's other ways to do this
in the other direction if you want to
subtract one from a variable you can use
any of the previous syntax using a minus
sign instead of Plus or you can more
succinctly do counter minus minus this
is the way a typical C programmer would
do this all right so if we have now
variables let's go and solve the meowing
with loops so in scratch we saw Loops
like this this of course had the cat
meow three times how do we do this in C
now this this is where things get a
little more uh involved codewise but if
you understand each and every line it
will follow logically what's going on so
here I claim is one way to implement a
loop that iterates three times in C and
this is kind of ridiculous right like we
went from two super simple puzzle pieces
like this to my God like it's 1 2 3 four
five six lines of code all of which are
pretty involved so like that escalated
quickly but what's each line doing and
we'll see other ways to do this more
simply so we're izing a variable called
counter to three just like before why
well what does it mean to Loop or to
repeat something three times well it's
kind of like doing something three times
and then do it and then count down and
then do it and then count down and then
do it until you're all out of counts so
this is declaring a variable called
counter setting it equal to three then
I'm inducing a loop in C which is
similar in spirit to repeat three but
you have to do more of the math yourself
so I'm asking the question in
parentheses
while counter is greater than zero what
do I want to do well Pur the indentation
inside the curly braces I want to meow
one time and then to be clear what's
this last line of code doing if counter
starts off at three this makes it two by
subtracting one from it then what
happens by nature of a loop just like in
scratch it kind of knows to go back and
forth even though there's nice pretty
arrow in scratch and there isn't here C
knows to do this again and again and
again con stantly asking this question
and then updating this value at the end
so if I highlight just a few of these
steps the variable starts off at three
and actually let me simplify two I
claimed earlier that uh when using
single variables people very often just
call it I for INT or c for Char or s for
string unless you have multiple
variables so let me tighten the code up
and this already makes it look a little
more tolerable let me actually tighten
it up further and one more step so now
this is about as tight as succinct as
you can make this code at the moment so
what's actually going to happen here
well the first line of code executes and
that initializes I to 3 then we check
the condition while I is greater than
zero is I greater than zero we'll per my
three fingers obviously so we print out
meow on the screen then we subtract one
from I at which point now we have two as
the value of I then the code goes back
to the condition and notice the
condition there is in parentheses that's
another Boolean expression so Loops can
use Boolean Expressions just like
conditionals use Boolean Expressions to
make decis ision the loop though is
deciding not whether to do this thing or
that but whether to do the same thing
again and again and again and as it
ticks through the code one line after
the other it's ultimately going to get
down to uh one and then zero and then
stop so put another way came with some
props here so suppose uh this bowl here
is your variable and you initialize it
to three with like three stress balls
you can do something three times right
if I want to give out three stress balls
here's your chance for free stress ball
without having to answer any questions
any okay there we go so here we go
subtracting one from my variable I'm
left with two uh oh my God all right uh
don't tell
Sounders oh I'm sorry oh okay that ended
poorly apologies all right but now the
educational point though is that my
variable has been uh decremented further
to just have I'm not throwing that far
again I can't do this in here we go all
right here we go and one final
subtraction and now our variable is left
so we have three stress balls there and
that's all a variable is right it's some
kind of storage it's actually of course
implemented in the computer's memory but
metaphorically it's really just like a
bow with some values and every time you
add or in this case subtract you're just
changing the value of that variable and
then the code meanwhile of course in
parenthesis is just checking is the bow
empty is the bowl empty is the bowl
empty AKA is I greater than zero or not
any questions on how we've implemented
Loops in this way
and I I'll you a stress ball after class
questions on Loops all right so it turns
out this is kind of ugly and like this
really starts to take the fun out of
programming uh when you have to like
write out this uh sequence of steps so
it turns out there's other ways to do
this but first let's see logically how
else you might Express this because it's
a little weird that we keep using zero
so the one other way to do this would be
to invert the logic you could absolutely
start with your variable call it I equal
to one and then you ask the question is
I less than or equal to three and notice
a bit of new syntax here on your uh
typical keyboard there is no less than
or equal sign or greater than or equal
sign like you would write in math class
with one over the other and so in C you
use two characters less than followed by
an equal sign or if appropriate greater
than followed by an equal sign and that
logically captures that idea so notice
that I'm kind of changing my questions
I'm initializing I to one and then I'm
going to increment It ultimately to two
and then three but because I'm doing
less than or equal to it's still going
to go from 1 to three so that works too
we could similarly do this yet another
way we could initialize I to zero and
then we could say well I is less than
three and keep incrementing it and I
showed this last form is actually the
most canonical like it might be the most
humanlike to think in terms of 1 to
three it might be the most stress ball
like to think in terms of three to zero
counting down but Ty typically the go-to
Syntax for most programmers once you get
comfortable counting from zero is to
always start counting from zero and
count up to less than the value you're
counting up to so it would be incorrect
why to change this to less than or equal
to three here what would happen if I
Chang the less than to less than or
equal to it'll me out twice yeah it'll
out an extra a fourth time in fact total
right because you'll start at zero then
one then two then three and less than or
equal to three sorry three will give you
the fourth time so we do want it indeed
to be just a single less than all right
so now that we have those options let me
just give you one other and this one
takes a little more getting used to as
well but it's probably the more common
way to write this let me go ahead and
propose that we implement this as
follows let me go back to my code here
let me go into my several printfs
getting rid of all but one of them
ultimately and let's implement this in
code so let's do in I get that's zero
how about then while I is less than
three then let's go ahead and say print
F quote unquote meow uh mellow meow back
sln and then we have to do I minus minus
or plus
plus so plus plus because we're starting
at zero and going up two but not through
three so let me go ahead now and make
meow after clearing my terminal SL meow
and it's still just as correct but it's
a little more uh it's a little better
designed why because now if I want to
change it from three to 30 times for
instance I can change it there I can
recompile my code I can do/ meow and
done I don't have to copy and paste it
27 more times to get that effect and I
can even change what the word is by
changing it in just one location but it
turns out there's other ways to do this
too and let me propose that we introduce
you to what's called a for loop as well
so if you want to repeat something three
times you can absolutely take the while
Loop approach that we just saw or you
can do this and this one's a little
takes a little more getting used to but
it kind of consolidates into one line
all of the same logic so notice we have
the keyword four here and four is just a
a preposition in this case that
generally implies here comes a loop
inside of parenthesis here is not just a
Boolean expression and this where things
get a little weird there's three things
to the left of the semicolon in the
middle of the two semicolons and to the
right of the semicolon this is really
the only other context we'll see
semicolons and it's weird normally it's
been at the end of the line now it's two
of them in the middle of the line but
this is the way humans decided years ago
to do it so what is this doing almost
the same thing it is going to initialize
a variable called I to zero it's going
to then check if it's less than three
it's then going to do what's ever in the
curly braces is and it's lastly going to
increment I and repeat so just
highlighting in turn at first I is
initialized to zero just like before
then this condition is checked this is a
Boolean expression yes or no true or
false will be its answer and if I is
less than three which it should be once
it starts at zero well then we're going
to go ahead and print out meow then I is
going to get incremented so it starts at
zero it goes now to one at that point
the Boolean expression is checked again
so you don't keep changing I back to
zero that first step happens only once
but now you repeat through those three
other highlights I check if I is less
than three it is so I print out meow it
then increments I I check if I now two
is less than three it is I print out
meow I gets incremented I now check is I
less than three no it's not because
three is not less than three and so the
whole thing stops and whatever code is
below this curly brace if any starts
executing instead just like in scratch
you break out of the loop and the the
puzzle piece being hugged questions then
about this alternative Syntax
for Loops AKA a four
Loop sorry say
again yeah can I explain again why it
doesn't reset to zero honestly just
because like this was the syntax they
chose this first part before the first
semicolon is only executed once just
because that's how it's designed
everything else Cycles again and again
and this is just an alternative syntax
to to using the slightly more lines of
code it was like six lines of code using
the while loop logically it's the same
thing programmers once they get more
comfortable tend to prefer this because
it just expresses all your same thoughts
more succinctly that's all yeah okay so
let's just work this into my meow
example let me go back to the code here
and notice indeed if I highlight all
these lines I think we can tighten this
up let me get rid of all of those and
instead do four in I equals 0 and I'm
saying equals most programmers would say
gets so in I gets zero means assignment
the word get now I'm going to do I is
less than three i+ plus now in here I'm
going to do my print F quote unquote
meow back sln and so it's indeed a
little tighter I mean two of the lines
are just curly braces there's really
only two juicy lines of code now let me
go ahead and do make
meow meow and again we're back in
business with three of them printing
only all right there's one last
structure we should explore just cuz
it's sometimes useful this was a forever
block and this would be a little weird
in scratch to just say meow Forever at
least without waiting but there is
indeed a forever Block in scratch which
means do the following forever and I
proposed I think verbally last week's at
least one example where this is useful
meowing forever little annoying but can
you think of common cases where you
might want to write code or use a
program that Loops forever
yeah yeah playing music like Spotify
playlist just repeating again and again
would be some kind of loop for
collisions checking for collisions and
scratch so seeing if something's
bouncing off the wall or another Sprite
yeah checking for input so yeah get
string is essentially just waiting there
forever for me to type in some input
until I do the time checking the time
and actually maintaining like human time
like a wall clock behind you was that
the
same okay checking the time and one more
detecting a key press too like in
scratch just waiting for some kind of
event to happen just like on a phone or
a browser and so there's so many
examples where you might want to do
something forever just so you've seen
the corresponding C building block it's
a little weird but this is probably the
most canonical way to do it in C if you
want to print meow forever which would
be a little crazy because it literally
print and take over your computer
printing forever meow you would
generally do it like this why well a
while loop expects in parentheses a
Boolean expression and a Boolean
expression is again a yes no a true
false question but if you want the
answer to that question always to be yes
or really always to be true turns out in
C in a lot of languages well then just
say true because true T R is never going
to change magically to false I mean it's
just a special word in the programming
language so by saying while true it just
means do the following forever another
common Paradigm before true and false
became common place would be to do uh
this instead change uh while one you
might see in online examples and texts
and the like while one is really the
same thing any value that is zero is
generally interpreted as false by a
computer any value that is one or any
other nonzero value is generally
interpreted as true and so this too
would have the same effect saying while
true or while one generally speaking
while true is perhaps a little clearer
these days now meowing forever is not a
good thing but suppose I did that by
intent or by accident well let's try
this so here I'll go into my code I'm
going to get rid of my for Loop and
change my while loop to uh how about
true um and in this case here well we'll
keep it let's do this make meow enter
and you'll see this use of Undeclared
identifier or true this is actually
hinting at my mention that the old way
was zero and one nowadays you could say
true or false but true and false are
themselves special words that you have
to include and it turns out if you want
to use special Boolean values like this
there's another header file we haven't
seen called standard bu that essentially
creates true and false as keywords
alternatively cs50 includes that same
file so it's more common in cs50 to see
it like this now if I clear my terminal
window and do make meow and then do/
meow and hit enter well unfortunately
this isn't the best thing to do uh
infinitely when you're in the cloud
using a browser this is indeed a a
browser full screened here um this means
I'm sending millions of meows over the
internet to my computer here uh so this
will happen to you at some point
probably not with meow but you'll lose
control over your terminal window why
because you screwed up and like you have
an infinite Loop you didn't really
intend it or maybe you did you were
curious to see what happens what do you
do like when when does the meowing stop
what recourse do we have here all right
well control c will be your friend
sometimes you have to hit it a bunch in
a cloud environment but control C for
cancel with will interrupt a program
that's running and I promise that almost
all of you will at some point
accidentally introduce an infinite Loop
because you're math is slightly off when
in doubt click in the terminal window
and hit contrl C sometimes multiple
times and that will indeed cancel
whatever is happening there in this case
I might have intended it but sometimes
it's not in fact intended all right so
we've been taking for granted this whole
graphical user interface for some time
and indeed uh the uh commands that I'm
typing and the buttons I'm clicking and
let me just give you a better sense of
what it is we are using underneath the
hood this whole time um namely an
operating system called Linux so I keep
alluding verbally of course to Macs and
PCs because almost all of us are running
Mac OS or Windows on our desktops or
laptops nowadays but there's lots of
other operating systems out there and
one of the most popular one is called
Linux and Linux is very often used on
servers nowadays companies that host
email companies that host websites or
apps more generally um certain computer
scientists or computer science students
often like to brag that they run Linux
just because that's a thing um but it is
really just an alternative to Mac OS or
windows that provides you with both a
guey if you want it but also and
especially a command line environment
now fun fact Windows and Mac OS do have
terminal windows or the equivalent
thereof and eventually you might uh use
it on your own Mac or PC to solve some
problem but Linux is really known for
along with other operating systems it's
command line environment which again I
distinguished earlier from Guy as a
command line interface or CLI and that
refers really to the terminal window so
if I go back to VSS code here and let me
in fact go ahead and close my tab and
focus entirely on the terminal window
this terminal window is really just your
command line interface to your very own
server in the cloud the term of art here
is you each will have your own container
in the cloud which is like your own
computer running somewhere on the
internet with your own username and
password to which you have access and
your own hard drive if you will your own
home folder that has all of your files
for the class and it's only accessible
to you unless you enable live sharing
thereof so when you're typing commands
here it looks like you're typing them of
course on your own Mac or PC but they're
actually being sent over the browser to
uh some server in the cloud where you
are controlling really your own account
therein so it turns out that there are
other commands that are worth knowing
and we'll give you just a few of these
today and over the coming weeks will you
have opport ities to play with others as
well but these are kind of some of the
basics and they're all incredibly
succinct because indeed for things
you're typing at the command line humans
generally have not wanted to type out
long commands so a lot of these are
abbreviations here now perhaps the most
common one I'll start with first is LS a
lowercase l and a lowercase s that
stands for succinctly list so if I go to
my terminal window now where up until
now I've only typed code which is a vs
code thing for creating and opening
files and make which triggers the compil
ation of my code what if I now type LS
this will list all of the files in my
current folder my hard drive in the
cloud if you will so if I hit enter
you'll see a whole bunch of results now
they're color-coded too the white ones
here and in. c those are the source code
files I've written during class today
agree. C compare. C hello.c and meow. C
and you can perhaps guess the green ones
here that just by convention have an
asterisk on the end to denote that
they're special represent what
what are the four others
yeah yeah the machine code so those are
my actual programs that are identically
named minus the C extension and the
asterisk means that they're executable
that is in the world of Mac OS or
Windows you would double click but in
the world of a command line environment
that means you do dot slash and then the
name without the asterisk to execute or
run the code therein so if I open up my
file explorer and I'm hitting command B
on my computer here just as a keyboard
shortcut you'll see the exact same thing
so LS is the command line interface for
listing the files in your account but
here because I'm using vs code or any
program like it I also get a graphical
user interface as well so it's just two
different places to be you're welcome to
use whatever you're comfortable with but
over time will you naturally get more
comfortable and capable with the
terminal window alone well what else is
on this this list here well during the
break I saw that at least one of you for
instance had created a file called hello
instead of hello. so you were in a
situation where you did this
accidentally and hit enter and then you
went ahead and typed in all of your code
like this and then down in your terminal
window you were trying to do make hello
enter and this now didn't actually do
anything like I can't I'm hitting um I'm
trying to run the command I got
permission denied as at least one of you
did now why is that well let's just do a
quick check if I do LS I see now hello
but hello has no asteris next to it
which means it's not executable that's
my code why well notice the top of my
tab confirms oh I screwed up I didn't
name my file hello.c which it just has
to be so what do you do well you could
very hackish like copy this create a new
file paste it in or no no no like we
know how to rename things now here
because that's one of our options let me
do this let me do MV for move hello and
then hello.c and hit enter you'll see
the tab closes cuz hello no longer
exists but if I now now type LS you'll
see ah there is hello.c and if I open
that file now there's all of my same
code and now if I do make hello make
hello now I do get an executable file
wherein the world is restored so MV is
just a command not just for renaming but
it also turns out eventually for moving
files as well you can also create
directories or folders so for instance
if I go into vs code again and suppose I
hover over here and click not on the
plus file icon but plus folder I can
create a folder called for instance like
pset one for problem set one in the
class and you'll see now that it's empty
CU all of my other files are in the
default folder of my account but I could
also go in there like this and I could
click on file and now I can create a new
file called like mario.c which is uh one
of the first problems for instance but
you'll notice now that
mario.c is inside of the pet one folder
so if I zoom out and I type LS at my
terminal window
I won't see mario. C anywhere but I do
see a pet one folder and it's in light
blue followed by a slash which you don't
have to type it just indicates that's a
folder now I can visually at top left
obviously see pet one contains mario.c
but if I try to do something like make
Mario here no rule to make Target Mario
like it just doesn't seem to exist and
that's because you're in the wrong
directory so in a command line interface
it's not quite as simple as just
clicking on a folder and voila it opens
you have to change into the directory or
folder and CD is going to be the command
there so if I want to actually change
into that directory I can do CD space
pet one enter and now you'll see my
prompt changes and this is just a common
convention but it's not the only one out
there now I still have a dollar sign
which indicates where I can type
commands but before it I see a reminder
constantly what folder I'm in and we put
that there deliberately like a lot of
Linux users do just to remind themselves
where they are cuz unlike Mac OS where
you or Windows where you have a nice big
window telling you where you are at the
command line you kind of need to be
reminded textually but now if I type LS
and hit enter what should I
see yeah mario.c and now if I want to
open it uh if I want to uh actually
compile it I can run make Mario in this
directory once I actually type out all
the code rest assured that in problem
sets in Labs we almost always certainly
in the first weeks of the class give you
exactly the commands to type odds are
because it's new to many of you view you
will accidentally type the wrong
commands no big deal just remember that
you have different ways to solve these
problems you've got like the graphical
file explorer which should feel a little
more familiar but in time you'll start
to know and honestly probably prefer
commands like these so CD for change
directory CP for copy a file uh LS for
list MK dirt to make a directory create
a new folder at the command line instead
of with the button MV for move or rename
RM
for remove so be careful with that one
RM dur remove directory and there's
dozens hundreds of other commands you
won't need many of them but we'll start
to scratch the surface all the more over
time but ultimately this command line
interface is going to be a more powerful
mechanism a more capable mechanism and
ultimately a more efficient mechanism
for writing code running commands uh
solving problems analyzing data more
generally even though no there's going
to be some uh some Growing Pains early
on just because it's probably so new for
many of you so with that said we have
some problems still to solve but we
promised cookies today so let's go ahead
and take a 10-minute break cookies are
now served in the transcept and we'll be
back here in
10 all right we are back and up until
now each of the code examples in C we've
done if been kind of designed to show
one specific topic but we thought we'd
try to take a step back and solve a more
General problem and give you a sense of
when given a problem set for instance or
just a programming problem more
generally like where you even begin and
how you go about approaching it when
it's not obvious what the point of the
exercise is so one of my favorite games
from yester year is this one here Super
Mario Brothers that has come in so many
different forms since but in this
original uh two-dimensional Sid scroller
game there was a lot of artwork like
this so for instance up here in the sky
were four question marks and we'll find
that in C in a lot of programming
languages initially it's a lot easier a
lot more accessible to focus really on
black and white type interactive
programs textually as opposed to
full-fledged graphics and the like but
more on the more Gra graphical acoustic
uh type of programs before long but for
now let me go over and propose that we
try to just Implement an asy art aski
again being the code that Maps numbers
to letters at least for English um into
a textual version of these four question
marks in the sky so for this let me go
over to vs code I'll create my own
version of mario.c that will be
different from the one you're challenged
with in problem set one indeed in
problem set one you'll be challenged to
build a little something like this
albeit with hashtags uh for asky art
instead of graphics and in mario.c I
want to just solve this simple problem
first so it's all involving output so
I'll do include standard i.h so I can
use printf I'll do my int main void more
on why we keep doing that in future
weeks and I'm just going to do something
simple initially like 1 2 3 4 back sln
this is about the simplest way I can
Implement four question marks in the sky
like these here using pure text like
this so let me go ahead and do make
Mario / Mario and voila we have those
four question marks but we've seen of
course that there are better ways to do
this and if you wanted to generalize
this to be five question marks six 60
different question marks you know Loop
was always the answer for not repeating
ourselves so maybe I should rewrite this
a little bit more flexibly and say
something like this four in I gets zero
I less than four I plus plus and then
inside of the for Loop now I can just do
a single question mark But I don't think
what I've just done is correct anyone
spot the aesthetic bug
already yeah why is this why is this
wrong if I want to print the same thing
[Music]
yeah yeah so I don't think I want to
backs slash in after every question mark
because the goal is again this like row
of question marks in the sky so if I now
recompile this make
Mario Mario okay it's almost there but
now I have that regression to where the
dollar sign's not on its own line so I
think I need a new line but I don't
think I want it here cuz that was not
going to end well where do I want it
instead any Instinct
yeah yeah so outside the for Loop so
indeed I can just go below line eight
and above line nine creating a new one
and now there's it's totally fine to
just print a new line like that you
don't have to print anything else with
it it's indeed a character unto itself
so let's do make Mario one last time/
Mario okay so now we're back in business
there well what if we wanted to do some
other scene from Mario uh such as this
one here where there's a lot of vertical
obstacles like the These Bricks here if
I wanted to print out now a column of
three bricks and I'll use hashtags for
these instead of anything graphical well
I think we're almost there right like I
think I can now it's almost maybe a
little easier I can go back here change
the question mark to something that
looks more like a brick like this hash
symbol and I think now I do want the new
line character because when I now do
make Mario Mario okay there's my wall of
four oh but wait I didn't want four I
wanted to be consistent just with this
particular scene here so I just want
three so I can still change it in one
place and here again is that Paradigm
even whether you're using four or three
if you get into the habit of starting
counting from zero you go on up to but
not through the value you want to count
up to so that's why I'm using less than
instead of less than or equals to there
so this would be the common Paradigm
though you could certainly count it like
we saw earlier in different ways but
what if things escalate one level
further and when you're in the
underground version of Super Mario
Brothers there's a lot of these
underground obstructions including like
grids of bricks like this and let me
conjecture that if you slice this up
it's roughly a 3X3 grid of bricks that
all interlock uh prettily to give us
just one big large brick like this so if
I want to print out a 3X3 grid now
things are getting a little more
interesting because up until now I
printed either one row horizontally or
one column vertically but we haven't
really seen any code where I'm sort of
printing or living in two different
dimensions like the game would imply but
let me propose that we could do this let
me go ahead and say all right suppose I
want to print a 3X3 grid of bricks it's
really that I want to print what three
rows of bricks like a grid is three rows
so if I take the highle idea and reduce
it to something a little simpler how do
I do that well let me get rid of the
print for a moment as I did and let me
just stipulate that this for Loop even
though it doesn't do anything useful yet
will do something how many times just by
Design all right three times right this
for Loop is good to go it will do
something three times by just using I to
do the counting all right well if I want
to print out now a row of three bricks
all on the same line that's pretty
similar to what we did earlier when I
just wanted to print out four question
marks in the sky so we've kind of seen a
solution there and I dare say we can
compose one into the other so if I want
to print out a row of bricks I could
just do this four in I gets zero I less
than three I ++ and then inside of this
inner loop if you will let me print out
a single brick like this and then I I
don't like where this is going yet but I
think I've taken two ideas and I've
combined them but what might be
problematic about lines five and seven
at the moment
what might be bad here uh yeah and
back yeah I'm using the same integer ey
which I feel like could get me into
trouble right if I'm sort of trying to
count three things here but then I'm
hijacking this variable and using it
inside of the loop like I feel like I
should avoid this this Collision of
names and so what's a good alternative
to I well a programmer if nesting Loops
in this way would pretty commonly go
with J you could certainly change this
to be like rows and columns if you want
more descriptive variables but I and J
is pretty canonical so I'm going to go
ahead and do this j++ instead of i++
everywhere and let me try compiling this
so make Mario
enter
Mario okay so a couple of things are
wrong here this is not a 3X3 grid but if
you count these things how many did I
indeed print at
least can probably just guess logically
yeah there's nine hashes there
unfortunately they're all on the same
line instead of on three different lines
so where logically can I fix this I'm
definitely printing all the bricks
they're just not on the right levels
yeah yeah so put a new line after the
first Loop this inner loop if you will
the nested Loop if you will so let me go
ahead and print out just a back slash n
here and what's this doing well I think
that's going to solve it by just moving
the cursor to the next line after you've
done one row so let me go ahead and do
make Mario enter SL Mario and now we're
in business so it's a very simplistic
version of the same graphic but I'm
leveraging two different ideas now the
same or the same idea twice rather now
I'm using one Loop to kind of control my
cursor going row by row by row but then
within that Loop I'm doing left to right
do do dot dot dot with printing out each
of these individual bricks like this now
there's a little sloppiness here still
like if I want this to always be a
square just because that's what it looks
like in the game well I could change it
to be a 4x4 uh Square by doing this or a
5x5 grid whoops by doing this why is
this perhaps not the best design to just
keep changing the numbers when I want to
change the
size where could this go AR
yeah yeah if it's always going to be a
square and height is going to be the
same as width I'm just inviting trouble
here right eventually I'm going to screw
up I'm going to change one but not the
other then it's going to come out to be
a rectangle instead of a proper Square
so I should probably solve this a little
differently so let me do that at the top
of my main function here let me go ahead
and give myself a variable called maybe
uh n for the number of bricks I want
horizontally and vertically and I'll
just initialize that to three initially
and instead of putting three here I'll
literally just use n but I'll do it in
both places so that now henceforth if I
ever want to change this and change it
to four or five or anything else like
I'm all done like it's better designed
because there's a lower probability of
mistakes but I could technically SK
still screw up somehow I could
technically accidentally write line of
code like n++ or you know I could just
change the value of that variable even
though I don't want it to ever change
and maybe it's because I'm a bad
programmer I copy pasted wrong I'm
working with someone who doesn't know
what n represents I can defend myself
and my code against human error like
that by going up here to line five and
instead of just declaring a simple
variable like we did in scratch I can
further Harden my code so to speak by
declaring it to be a constant using the
keyword const now this is just a feature
of c and some other languages to protect
you against Yourself by proactively
saying N is a constant specifically the
number five or previously the number
three you cannot accidentally write code
elsewhere that changes it the computer
will throw an error and catch that error
so it's just a way of programming a
little more defensively um some
languages have this some languages don't
but in general it's a good practice it
makes your code better designed because
it just is less vulnerable to Mistakes
by you colleagues or anyone else using
the code so let me change this back to
three just to be our default but now I'm
using n in both places and if I do make
mario. Mario we're back to where we
originally started but the code's a
little more better design and let me
note this too all this time I've been
mentioning that uh there's correctness
is important design is important there
was also this matter of style I've been
very deliberately writing pretty code if
you will not just the syntax
highlighting which is automatic but
notice that I keep indenting everything
nicely anytime I have curly braces like
on lines 4 and 14 everything is indented
one level when I have additional curly
braces on line 7 and 13 everything is
nicely indented uh as well technically
speaking the computer does not care
about that kind of white space so to
speak and you could really make a mess
of things like this because you have a
strange sense of style or just because
you're being a little sloppy but this
code is actually still correct if I
recompile it let me open up my terminal
window make uh Mario no errors Mario it
works perfectly fine but you can imagine
just how annoying this now is to read
like certainly for a TA U but certainly
for you the next day certainly for a
colleague who has to read your code this
is just bad style like it still works
and it's welld designed in that like
you're uh writing code defensively
you're using a constant but my God the
style is atrocious now you'll often find
that there's tools that can help you
format your code for you in a manner
consistent with a courses or a company's
uh style but this is the kind of muscle
memory you'll want to develop over time
to take vs code suggestions as it's
outputting lines of code for you because
it's trying to format your code in a
readable way and oh my God if and when
you do have bugs in your code and things
aren't even indented properly there's no
way you the human are going to be able
to wrap your mind around what's
happening and where like you're just
making the problem harder for yourself
so do get into this habit too of
manifesting good style as well all right
well let me propose that we don't only
want a 3X3 grid we want this to be a
little more Dynamic so suppose we moved
away from a constant to just using an
integer called n and let's ask the user
for the size of this grid as by
prompting them with get int as we've
done before and I'll store it in N here
and then I can go ahead and more
dynamically run make Mario to compile it
whoops oh I screwed up
accidentally what is it in suggesting I
do albeit
cryptically yeah I forgot to include the
cs50 header file up top and that's why
it doesn't know that get int is in fact
valid so that's an easy fix U I'm just
going to go up here and include
cs50.h now I'm going to clear my
terminal and rerun make Mario now we're
good Mario and now notice I'm prompted
for size so if I type in three it's the
same as before if I type in 10 it's even
bigger but it happens all now
automatically but there are some things
that we're not detecting for instance
suppose I type in cat well that's
handled by the get it function as I
claimed earlier that's one of the
features of using a library you don't
have to deal with erroneous input but we
only designed a function called get int
to get you an integer we don't know if
you want it to be positive negative zero
or some combination thereof and it's
kind of weird to allow the user to type
in like negative one for the size of the
Grid or you know ne3 for the size of the
grid and indeed your code does nothing
so at least it's not crashing but that's
kind of stupid right like it'd be nice
to force the user if they want a grid to
give us a positive value so how could we
do this well I could go up here and I
could say something like if n is less
than one so if it's zero or negative
which I don't want what could I do well
I could say well prompt the user again
for the size and now notice I'm not
declaring and again because once it
exists you don't have to mention the
data type again we said that earlier but
this is kind of stupid why because now
when You' given the user a second chance
okay now maybe I'll do all right if this
version of n is less than one well let's
just go and prompt the user a third time
I mean you can kind of see where this is
stupidly going like this can't be the
right solution to keep typing
recursively the same thing again and
again like where would it stop you'd
have to give them a finite number of
chances or just you know make a mess of
your code so what would be intuitively a
better solution
here yeah so some kind of loop we've
seen a while loop we've seen a four Loop
so maybe one of those so let me try this
let me delete this messiness and just go
back to the first question and let me do
this so while n is less than one so
while the number is not what we want
let's just prompt the user in a loop
this time for the size again now here
too this is better because it's only two
requests for information but clearly
line six and N are pretty much identical
other than the int and if I went in and
changed the size you know uh if I add
this if I change the wording here change
it to a different language like I have
to change it in two places that's bad
copy paste bad so what might be better
well it turns out there's another
Paradigm in C that you can use that gets
around this problem this duplication of
code it would be much nicer if I just
write this code once and I can do that
using a third type of loop called a do
while loop so it turns out in C you can
do this if you want to get the value of
a variable like n first just decree
create the variable without an initial
value so int n semicolon means it we
don't know what value it has yes but
that's okay we're going to add a value
to it eventually then I'm going to say
this do literally I'm going to open my
curly braces and what do I want to do I
want to assign to n the return value of
get in prompting the user for size well
when do you want to do that I want to do
that while n is less than one and this
code now achieves the exact same goal
but by never repeating myself why well
notice on these lines of code now I'm
literally saying on line six give me a
variable called n of type integer it
doesn't have a value initially but
that's fine you can do that line seven
says do the following what do you want
to do get int prompting the user with
the word size and just store that value
in N but because code runs top to bottom
left to right now it's reasonable on
line 11 to ask that question okay is the
current value of n which it definitely
got on line a less than one and if the
user didn't cooperate they typed in zero
or Nega 1 or3 what's going to happen
it's going to go back up here and repeat
repeat repeat everything in the do while
loop so a do while loop in C which is
not something some other languages have
like python if you know it does not have
a do while loop this is perhaps the
cleanest way to achieve this even though
it's a little weird that you have to
declare your variable create your
variable up top and then check it down
below but other wise it's similar to a
while loop it just flips the order in
which you're asking the question any
questions on this construct and Doh in
general is super useful when you want to
get input from the user and make sure it
meets certain requirements all right so
now that we have this building block
after that interlude how can I go about
cleaning up this code and then let's
conclude by taking a look at things that
our code can't do or can't do very well
or correctly let me propose that in a
final version of Mario let me just add
what are called now some comments so it
turns out in code in C you can Define
what are called comments which are just
notes to self some of you discovered
these in scratch there's little yellow
sticky notes you can use to add
citations or explanations in C there's a
couple of ways to write comments and in
general comments are notes for yourself
for your ta for your colleague as to
what your code is doing and why or how
it's a little explanatory note in
English or whatever your human language
might be so for instance what I might do
here in my implementation of this
version of Mario I might first ask
myself a question like I I might first
make a note to S like this on a new line
above this first block of code uh get
size of Grid it's just an explanatory
remark in any tur English that generally
explains the next six or so lines the
next chunk or block of code if you will
it would be a little excessive to
comment every single line at some point
the programmer should know what
individual lines of code do but it's
nice to be able to kind kind of glance
at this comment on line six that starts
with two slashes and it gets gray out
because of syntax highlighting it's not
logic it's just a note to self it
generally gives me a little cheat sheet
as to what the following lines of code
should be doing and or why and then down
here well there's a second block of code
that's a bunch of lines but together
this just what prints uh grid of bricks
and so it's another comment to myself
that just makes it a little more
understandable what these 20 some odd
lines of code are doing by adding some
English explanations thereof but now
that I have these you know wouldn't it
be nice if I could kind of abstract
these pieces of functionality away this
getting of the size and this printing of
the Grid in other words suppose that you
didn't know where to begin with this
problem and the problem at hand were
literally Implement a program that
prints a grid of bricks of some variable
size three or four or five or whatever
the human types in if you have really no
idea where to start comments are
actually a good way of getting started
because comments can be a approximation
of what we called last week pseudo code
pseudo code is tur English that kind of
gets your point across like for the uh
phone book searching like last time so
if you didn't really know where to begin
you could do something like this I could
for instance just say get size of grid
as my first step and then print grid of
bricks as my second step and that's it
for my program thus far this is now
implemented in pseudo code I have some
massive placeholders there like I still
have work to be done but at least I have
a highle solution to the problem in
comments and now I can even go this far
I could say well let's suppose that
there's just a function already that
exists called get size I could do
something like this I could do Inn
equals get size and now I just have to
assume for the moment that some
abstraction called get size exists it
doesn't this does not come with the
cs-50 library but I could invent it I
bet how else might I proceed well let's
just assume for the moment that there's
also a function called print grid that
just prints that a grid of that size n
so here too is an abstraction these
puzzle pieces don't exist these
functions don't yet exist but in C just
like in scratch I can create my own
functions how do I do that well let me
go down later in the file and by
convention you generally want to leave
main at the top of your code why because
it's the main function and it's just
where the human eye is going to look to
see what some file of code does and let
me do this I want to create a function
of my own called get size whose purpose
in life is to get the size that the user
wants I want this function to return an
integer and the Syntax for doing that is
this write similar to a variable the
data type that this function returns I
don't need this function to take any
inputs and so I'm going to use a new
keyword that we've actually been using
thus far more on it another time just
called void which just means this get
size function does not take any inputs
it does have an output it outputs an INT
and this is just a weird order in which
you write it you write the output format
the name of the function and then the
inputs if any inside of parentheses and
now I can Implement get size but I've
already implemented get size or at least
now at this point in the story I at
least know concretely what to do and I
could figure out eventually with some
trial and error perhaps all right if I
declare a variable and I do the
following n equals get in prompting the
user for size and I keep doing that
while n is less than one once that block
of code is done here is a new keyword in
C where you can return that value n so I
keep referring to these values that some
functions return as return values in C
there's literally a keyword called
return that will hand back to any
function that uses that function the
value in question so in a nutshell
between lines 15 and 21 now here is some
code identical to our solution earlier
that gets a value n from the user that
is positive it's one or two or higher
it's not zero or it's not less than one
and as soon as we've got that value we
hand it back as a return value notice
how I'm using this function on line
7even just like with get int just like
with get string I'm calling the function
nothing in the parenthesis in this case
but then I'm using the assignment
operator to copy whatever its return
value is into my variable n and so now I
have a function that didn't used to
exist called get size that gets me a
positive integer no matter what and now
for the grid how do I do this how do I
invent a function called print grid that
takes a single argument a number and
prints a grid of that size well let's go
down here I'm going to write the name of
this function print grid this function
just needs to print it has a side effect
as we keep saying so I'm just going to
say it has no return value it's just
void it doesn't have an output per se
it's just an aesthetic side effect but
it does take an an argument an argument
is an input and the Syntax for this in C
is to name the type of the input it
takes
and the name of the variable and I could
call this anything I want I'll call it
size I could call it n and it's okay to
use the same variable in different
functions but I'll call it size just to
be distinct and then in this function
I'm just going to copy from memory the
same code as before for in I get zero I
less than size instead of three I ++
inside of this four uh int J gets zero J
is less than size j++ and inside of that
print print out with print f a single
hash print out after that Loop a single
new line and that's it now I did this
fast admittedly but it's the same code
that I wrote earlier but now just like I
did with scratch let me just arbitrarily
hit enter a bunch of times to like move
the code out of sight out of mind now I
have abstractions I have puzzle pieces
that now exist called get size and print
grid Syntax for which takes some getting
used to but they now just exist except I
do need to do one thing because C is a
little naive if I try to do make Mario
now and hit enter implicit Declaration
of function get size is invalid and
we've seen that before when I hadn't
included a file right when I hadn't
included cs50 Library get in didn't work
but that's not the issue here because
this is not from a library I just
invented this C kind of takes you
literally and if you define these
functions at the bottom of your file
they don't exist on line seven or 10 so
I could do this I could all right fine
well let me just kind of highlight all
of this cut with to my clipboard and
paste it up here this would solve the
problem I could just move all of those
functions at the top of my file that's
kind of annoying because now main is
like the bottom of the file you're not
it's going to take longer to find it
it's just that's not a clean solution so
let me put it back where it was at the
bottom and let me do this this is the
only time in cs50 and really in C
programming where copy paste is
reasonable if you copy and paste the
first line of code from each function
and then end it with a semicolon you can
tease the compiler by giving it just
enough of a hint at the top of the file
that okay these functions don't exist
till down later but here's a hint that
they will exist this is how you can uh
convince the compiler to trust you so
those other functions can still be lower
in the file below main but now when I do
make Mario oh damn it oh I said print
instead of print F that's my
bad print f
so if I do make
Mario Mario now I can type in three and
we're back in business now this was a
very heavy-handed way and long way to
get to a much more complicated solution
but this solution in some sense is
better designed why because now
especially without the comments I mean
look how short my code is my main
function is literally two lines of code
why well I kind of factored out the
juicy stuff into its own functions and
now especially if I'm working with
colleagues or others you could imagine
splitting up up large programs into
smaller parts having different people
Implement different parts so long as you
all agree in advance on what those
inputs and those outputs actually are
all right so let's now consider what
computers can do well and not so well C
indeed supports a whole bunch of
operators mathematically via which we
can do addition and subtraction
multiplication division and even
calculate the remainder when you divide
one number by another in fact why don't
we go ahead and use these in a very
simple program and make our very own
calculator so let me go over here here
to vs code let me go ahead and create a
new file called calculator. C and in
this file let's go ahead and first
include a couple of now familiar header
files
cs50.h as well as standard i.h let's go
ahead then and declare main with int
main void and then inside of main let's
do something relatively simple let's
declare an INT and call it X and set it
equal to whatever the return value is of
get int prompting the user for a value
for x let's then give ourselves a second
variable we'll call it say y set that
equal to the return value of another
call to get int prompting the user this
time for that value Y and then let's
very simply go ahead at the very end and
just print out say the sum of X Plus y a
super simple calculator so I'll use
print F quote unquote percent I for
integer back sln to give me the new line
then I'm going to go ahead and do x + y
to indeed print out the sum let me go
down to my terminal window now let me do
make calculator in order to compile the
C no error messages so that's good let
me do/ calulator and let's do something
like 2 + 2 which of course should equal
4 and it does but it turns out that
sometimes there are going to be
limitations that we bump up against and
let me get a little more ambitious here
let me clear my terminal window and let
me go ahead and rerun calculator again
and this time let's type in
O2 billion for x and let's type in the
same for y and of course now the answer
of 2 billion plus 2 billion should have
of course be 4 billion and yet it's not
so curiously we see of all things a
negative number here which suggests that
somehow the plus operator doesn't quite
work as well as we might like now why
might this actually be well it turns out
that inside of your computer is of
course memory or Ram random access
memory and depending on the size of your
computer and the type of computer it
might very well look a little something
like this a little circuit board with
these black little modules on it that
actually contain all of the btes of your
computer's memory unfortunately you and
I only have a finite amount of this
memory inside of our computers which
means no matter how high we want to
count there's ultimately going to be a
limitation on high how we can count
because we only have a finite amount of
memory we don't have an infinite number
of zeros and ones to play with we have
to actually be bounded ultimately so
what's the implication of this well it
turns out that computers typically use
as many as 32 bits zeros or ones to
represent something like an integer or
in C an INT so for instance the smallest
number we could represent using 32 ins
of course using 32 bits of course would
be zero 32 zeros like this here and the
biggest number we could represent is by
changing all of those zeros to ones
which in this case will ideally give us
a number that equals roughly 4 billion
in total it's actually 4 billion 294 mil
967 295 maximally if you set all 32 of
those bits to ones and then do out the
actual math the catch though is that we
humans and Compu in general also
sometimes want to and need to be able to
represent negative numbers so if you
want to represent negative numbers as
well as positive numbers in zero you
can't really just start counting at zero
and go all the way up to roughly four
billion you got to kind of split the
difference and maybe allocate half of
those patterns of zeros and ones to
negative numbers and the other half
roughly to positive numbers so in fact
in practice when you're using even as
many as 32 bits the highest most
computers could count certainly in a
program like this in C using an INT
would be roughly 2 billion that is 2 b47
m
483,000 flow where you want to use more
bits than you have available and as a
result you sort of overflow the
available space what does this mean in
fact in real terms well let's suppose
that you only have three bits but I'm
going to gray out a fourth bit just to
convey where we'd like to uh put an
additional bit ultimately if this of
course is zero per week zero discussion
this is 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 now ideally in
binary if you want to add one more to
this value seven you're going to have to
carry the one mathematically and that
would ideally give you 1 0 0 0 but if
you don't have four bits and your
computer's only sophisticated enough to
have three bits not even 32 but three
the implication is that you're
effectively representing not one0 0 but
rather 0 z0 there's just no room to
store that fourth bit that I've gray out
here which is to say that your integer
might overflow and as soon as you get to
seven the next number once you add one
is actually going to be zero or worse as
we've seen here in my code a negative
value instead so what could we do to
perhaps address this kind of concern
well C does not have just integers or
ins it also has Longs which as the name
suggest or just longer integers which
means they have more bits available to
them so let me go back into my code here
I'll clear the terminal window and let
me go ahead and change my integers to
literally long here long here I'm going
to have to change my function in
uh cs50's library to be not get in but
get long and that's indeed another
function we provide in the library let
me change this get in to get long as
well I'll keep my variable names the
same but I do need to make one other
change it turns out that print F also
support supports other format codes so
not just percent I for integers or
percent s for Strings but also for
instance percent Li for a long integer
as well as percent f for floating Point
values with decimals so with that said
let's go ahead and change my print F
line to be not perc I but percent Li I
now let me go ahead and do make
calculator again enter no apparent
errors now do/ calulator and 2 + 2 still
equals 4 as before but now if I do
calculator again and let's do
two billion again as well as 2 billion
for y previously we overflowed the size
of an integer and got some weird
negative number because the pattern was
misinterpreted if you will as a negative
number instead but along instead of
using using 32 bits conventionally uses
64 bits which means we have more than
enough spare bits to go when we add 2
billion plus 2 billion and now in fact
we get the correct answer of four
billion which does fit inside of the
size of a long now along can count up
quite high and in fact it can count as
high as this nine quintilian and so that
will give us quite a bit more Runway but
of course it too is ultimately going to
be finite so if you have numbers that
need to go bigger than that you might
still very well have a problem now
there's another problem that we might
run into as well and we can see it in
the context of even this simple
calculator computers also suffer from
potentially what's called truncation
where especially when you're doing math
involving floating Point values that is
numbers with decimals you might
accidentally unknowingly truncate the
value that is lose everything after the
decimal point so in fact let me go back
to vs code here I'll clear my terminal
window and let's still use Longs but
let's go ahead and use division instead
of addition here so let me change this
plus to a divide operator let me go
ahead and recompile the code down here
with make calculator let me go ahead and
run/ calculator and let me go ahead and
do something like 14x and 3 for y and
we'll see that well wait a minute 1
divided 3 I learned should be 13 but in
a floating point value that should be
point0 it should be
0.33333 you know maybe with a little
line over in grade school but really an
infinite number of Threes And yet we
seem to have lost even one of those
threes after the decimal point because
the answer is coming back here as just
zero so why might that be well if I know
that two integers when divided one by
the other is supposed to give me a
fraction a floating point value with a
decimal point I can't continue to use
integers or even in this case Longs
which do not have support for decimal
points so let me go ahead and change
this format code here from percent Li I
to percent F which is again going to
represent a floating point value instead
of a long integer or even an integer and
let me go ahead further and Define maybe
a third variable Z as a float itself so
I'll give myself a variable Z equals x /
Y and now rather than print X ided Y
let's just go ahead and print Z so now
I'm operating in a world of floating
Point values because I know proactively
that an long or an INT divided by
another such value if it's meant to have
a fraction needs to be stored in a
floating point value something with a
decimal point well let me go down to my
terminal window here and rerun make of
calculator seems to work okay/ calulator
and let's do 1 / 3 again and still here
we see all zeros well so we do at least
see a decimal point so we've made some
progress thanks to the percent F in the
float but it seems that we've already
truncated the value 1 / 3 so how do we
actually get around this issue well if
you the program know that you're dealing
in a world that's going to give you
floating Point values with decimal
points you might very well need to use
what's called a feature known as typ
casting that is convert one data type to
another by explicitly telling the
compiler that you want to do so now how
do I do this well let's go back to my
code here and if the issue fundamentally
is that c is still treating X and Y as
integers or technically Longs with no
decimal point and dividing one by the
other therefore has no room so to speak
for any numbers after a decimal point
why don't I proactively do this let me
using a slightly new syntax with
parenthesis specify that I want to
convert X proactively from a long to a
float let me specify proactively that I
want to convert y from a long to a float
as well and now let me go ahead and
trust that in Z should be the result of
dividing not a long by a long or an INT
by an INT but rather a float by a float
Let Me Clear My terminal window run make
calculator again seems to work okay/
calulator and now 1 3 and hopefully now
we actually see that my code has
outputed
0.333 333 and I think if we kept showing
more numbers after the decimal point
we'd theoretically see as many of those
threes as we want but there is still one
more catch and especially when we're
manipulating numbers in this way in a
computer using a finite amount of memory
another challenge we might run up
against besides integer overflow besides
truncation is this known as floating
point in Precision just as we can't
represent as big of an integer as we
want using int or long alone because
there is going to be an upper bound
they're similarly going to be a boundary
on just how precise our numbers can be
and indeed let's go back to vs code here
I'll clear my terminal window yet again
and this time let me use some slightly
unley syntax to specify that I don't
want to see the default number of
numbers after the the decimal point
which percent F gives us automatically
let's go ahead and show me 20 decimal
point numbers after the decimal point
and the weird Syntax for this is to do
not percent F but percent period to zero
to indicate to see that I want to see 20
digits not the default after now the
decimal point let me rerun make
calculator let me do dot calculat again
and let's do one let's do three and now
this is even weirder right from grade
school you presumably learned that 1
divided 3 is of course 1/3 but that
should be
0.33333 infinitely many times or on
paper with a little line over it but the
computer is just doing some weird
approximation here it's a whole bunch of
Threes And then 43 267 44 079
590 well what's really happening under
the hood well again is this issue of
floating point in Precision if you only
have a finite number of bits and in turn
a finite amount of memory the computer
can really only be so precise
intuitively alter Converse or
equivalently the computer has decided on
some way of representing floating Point
values but the catch is per grade school
math there's an infinite number of
numbers out there and an infinite number
of floating Point values because you can
keep adding more and more digits if you
want so the computer given the way it's
implementing these floating Point values
is essentially giving us the closest
approximation that it can now how can we
go about improving the situation well
there is one alternative instead of
using float I can use something called a
double which as the name suggests uses
twice as many bits as a float so instead
of 32 typically it will use 64 and
that's just like the difference between
a long and an INT which gave us more
bits but in this case this will be used
for more Precision let's go ahead and
Cast X to a double let's cast y to a
double and now let's go ahead and using
the same format code percent 2f is still
okay for doubles let me do make
calculator let me do do slash calculator
and now let me do 1 / 3 and we still
have some of that in precision and we'd
see even more of it if we looked at more
than just 20 digits but now we have more
threes after the decimal point so it's
at least more more more precise but it's
not perfect but it it's at least more
precise so these kinds of issues then
are going to be necessary to keep in
mind anytime you do something
numerically scientifically at least with
a language like C where you're going to
bump up against these real world
limitations of hardware and intern
language now later in the semester we'll
transition to a language called Python
and that's actually going to solve at
least one of these problems for us but
just automatically giving us more bits
so to speak as we need them at least for
integers but even the issue of floating
point in Precision is going to remain
now just how real world are these issues
well back in the year 1999 we got a
taste of this when the world realized in
the Years leading up to that date that
it might not have been the best idea to
implement computers and software therein
by storing years using just two digits
like instead of storing 1999 to
represent the year 1999 a lot of
computers for reasons of space and cost
were in the habit of kind of cutting a
corner and just using two digits to keep
track of the year the problem with that
is that if systems were not updated by
the year 1999 to support the year 2000
2001 and so forth is that just like
before with integer overflow some
computers might add one to the year in
their memory 99 it should be the year
2000 but if they're only using two
digits to represent years they might
mistake the year as some systems may
very well have for the year 1900 instead
taking literally a big step backwards if
you will now you'd like to think that
kind of issue is behind us especially as
we understand all the more about the
limitations of code and Computing but
we're actually going to run up against
this very same type of issue again in
just a few years on January 19th in the
year
2038 we will have run out of bits in
most computers right now to keep track
of time it turns out years ago humans
decided to use a 32-bit integer to keep
track of how many seconds had elapsed
over time they chose a somewhat
arbitrary date in the past January 1st
1970 and they just started counting
seconds from there on out and so if a
computer stores some number of seconds
that tells the computer how many seconds
have passed since that particular date
January 1st 1970 unfortunately using a
32-bit integer as we've seen you can
only count so high at which point you
overflow the size of that variable and
so potentially if we don't get ahead of
this as humans as a society as computer
scientist on the date January 19th
2038 that bit might flip over there by
overflowing the size of those integers
bringing us back computationally to
December 13th
1901 so this is to say now with all of
this computational ability and code
comes a responsibility to actually write
correct code next week we'll peel back
some of these layers but for now this
was week one and best of luck on problem
set
[Music]
one
all right this is cs50 and this is this
is week two wherein we're going to take
a look at a lower level at how things
work and indeed among the goals of the
course isn't this bottom up
understanding so that in a couple of
weeks time even a few years time when
you encounter some new technology you'll
be able to think back hopefully on some
of this week's and this courses basic
building blocks and Primitives and
really just deduce how tomorrow's
Technologies work but along the way it's
going to seem it's going to be a little
hard perhaps to see the forest for the
tree so to speak and so the goal at the
end of the day still is going to be
problem solving and so we thought we'd
begin today with a look at some of the
problems we'll talk about or solve this
coming week uh and for that we have some
Brave volunteers who have already come
up if we could turn on some dramatic
lighting and meet today's
volunteers so on my left here we have hi
my name is Alex I'm a first year at the
college and I'm from Chapo North
Carolina Welcome to Alex and to Alex's
right um I'm Sarah I'm from Toronto
Canada and I'm also a first year student
at the college wonderful well welcome to
both Al and Sarah so one of the problems
you'll perhaps solve this week for
problem set two is to analyze the
reading level of a body of text whether
someone reads at a first grade level
second grade level third grade level all
the way up to 12 or 13 or Beyond but
you've perhaps never quite thought about
certainly in terms of code like how you
would analyze some text some book and
figure out what reading level is it at
and yet surely our teachers growing up
kind of knew or had an intuitive sense
of this so let's consider some sample
text for instance Alex what have you
been reading lately um
One Fish Two Fish Red F Fish Blue Fish
wonderful so given that what grade level
would you say Alex is currently reading
at feel free to just shout it
out first first so indeed you'll see
this week if you run your code on Alex's
text it actually turns out he reads
below a first grade reading level but
but why might that be what might your
intuition be for why we've
uh why we've accused Alex of reading at
this level feel free to shout
out yeah so very few syllables short
words short sentences and so there's
some puristic perhaps we can infer from
that short text that that probably means
that it's best for younger children now
Sarah by contrast what have you been
reading Mr and Miss dersley of number
four privet Drive were proud to say that
they were perfectly normal thank you
very much they were the last people
you'd expect to be involved in anything
strange or mysterious ious because they
just didn't hold with much nonsense all
right now irrespective of what grade you
were in when you might have read that
text what grade level does Sarah seem to
be reading
at so eighth grade second grade okay so
hearing a bit of everything so that at
least according to code would actually
be seventh grade and what might the
intuition there be why is that a higher
grade level even though we might
disagree exactly which grade it is comp
yeah so complicated sentences longer
sentences so indeed a lot more more
words were being spoken by Sarah because
there was so much more there on the page
so we'll translate these ideas this
coming week and problem set two if you
tackle this one to code so that you can
ultimately infer things of these
quantitatively but to do so we're going
to have to understand text so let's
first thank our volunteers and then
we'll dive in to that lower
level stress
balls sure you can keep those yeah all
right so besides that let's consider one
another body of text perhaps that you
might see this week which is namely a
little something like this what I have
here on the screen is what we'll start
calling today Cipher text it's the
result of encrypting some piece of
information and encryption or more
generally the Art and Science of
cryptography is all around us it's what
you're using on the web on your phones
with your Banks and anything that tries
to keep data secure is using encryption
but there's going to be different levels
of encryption strong encryption weak
encryption and what you see here on the
screen isn't all that strong but we'll
see later today how we might decrypt
this and actually reveal what the plain
text is that corresponds to that Cipher
text but in order to do so we have to
start taking off some training wheels so
to speak and believe it or not even
though your time with C this past week
for the first time probably might have
been rather in the weeds and much more
complicated seemingly than C it turns
out that along the way we have been
providing and will continue to provide
certain training wheels for instance the
cs50 library is one of them and even
some of the explanations give up topics
for now in these early weeks will be
somewhat simplified abstracted away if
you will but the goal ultimately is for
you to understand each and every one of
those details so that after cs50 you
really can stand on your own and
understand and wrap your mind around any
future Technologies as well so let's
consider first the very first program
with which we began last week which was
this one so hello world and C at the end
of the day it was really the print a
function that was doing the interesting
part of the work but there was a lot of
technical stuff above and below it the
the curly braces the parentheses words
like void and include and then of course
the angled brackets and more but at the
end of the day we needed to convert that
source code in C to machine code the
zeros and ones in binary that the
computer understood and to do that of
course we ran we compiled the code we
ran make and then we were able to
actually run that code there so let me
actually go over here to VSS code and
really quickly recreate that hello.c
pretty much by transcribing the same so
I have here uh include standard
i.h uh int main void and then in here I
had quite simply hello comma world with
my back slend quotes and more now last
time to compile this I indeed ran make
hello followed by enter hopefully you
see no errors and that's a good thing
and if you do do/ hello you see in fact
the results of that program but it turns
out that make is not actually a compiler
as I alluded to last week it's a program
that clearly makes your program but it
itself just automates the process of
using an actual compiler and there's
lots of different compilers out there
and the one that it's actually using
underneath the hood is a little
something called clang for C language
and clang is a pretty popular compiler
nowadays there's another one that's been
around for ages called GCC but these are
just specific names for types of
compilers that different people
different companies different groups
have actually created but if you use in
week one a compiler yourself manually
you have to know you have to understand
a little more about what's going on
because it's even more cryptic than with
just make a loan so in fact let me go
back to my terminal window here let me
go ahead and clear the screen a little
bit and just run really the raw compiler
command so what make is automating for
me let me actually do this manually for
just a moment so if I want to compile uh
hello.c into an executable program I can
run I can do this uh clang space hello
C and then enter and now there's no
output which is a good thing in this
case no errors but notice this if I go
ahead and type LS it turns out there's a
uh a file that's been created suddenly
in my current folder weirdly called
a.out that stands for assembler output
and long story short that's actually the
default name of a program that's created
when you just run C by itself now that's
a pretty uh bad name for a program
because it doesn't describe what it said
does so better would be here to perhaps
do well instead of a.out which yes still
prints hello. world but isn't really a a
clearly named program it'd be nice to
name this hello so what could I do I
could do like we learned last week well
I could rename a.out to Hello by using
linux's MV command so I'm going to move
a. out to become hello but that too
seems kind of tedious now I have three
steps like write my code compile my code
and then rename it before I can even run
it like we can do better than that and
so it turns out that certain commands
like clang support what we're going to
start today calling commandline
arguments a commandline argument unlike
an argument to a function is just an
additional word or key phrase that you
type after a command at your prompt in
your terminal window that just modifies
the behavior of that command it
configures it a little more specifically
so what you're seeing here on the screen
is a summary of a better command with
which to run clang so that now I can
specify the output of this command this-
o so what do I mean by that well let me
go ahead and clear my terminal window
again and more explicitly type clang d o
hello hello. C and then enter nothing
again appears to happen but that's a
good thing when you see no errors and
now the program I just created is indeed
called hello so it achieves really the
same exact effect as make did but what I
don't have to do with make is type and
remember something as long as this
command and this too is a bit of a white
lie it turns out we have preconfigured
vs code in the cloud for you to also use
some other features of clang that would
be even more tedious for you to write
yourselves and so really this is why we
distill this as ultimately just running
make so let me pause here to see first
if there's any questions on what I've
done by taking my very first program in
C and just now compiling it first with
make but then starting over and now
manually compiling it with clang with
what we'll call command line arguments -
o space hello and then the name of the
file
yeah yeah so a.out is a historical name
it refers to assembler output more on
that soon and it's just the default file
name that you get automatically if you
just run the compiler on any file so
that you have just a standard name for
it but it's not a very well-named
program instead of running Microsoft
Word on your Mac or PC it would like be
like double clicking on a.out so instead
with these command line arguments you
can customize the output of clang and
call it hello or anything you want other
questions on what I've done here with
clang itself the
compiler
yeah so- o and you would only know this
from reading the manual taking a class
means output so- o means change clangs
output to be a file called hello instead
of the default which is a.out and this
too is again a detail you would have to
uh look it up on a web page read the
manual hear someone like me tell you
about it and in fact there's even more
than these options but we'll just
scratch the surface here all right so if
we now know this what more is actually
happening underneath the hood well let's
take a a closer look at not just this
version of my code but my slightly more
complicated version last week which
looked a little something like this
wherein I added in some Dynamic input
from the user so I could say not Hello
World to everyone but hello David or
hello to whoever actually runs this
program so in fact let me go ahead and
change my code here in vs code just to
match that same code from last week so
no new code yet I'm just going to in a
moment compile it in a slightly
different way so I did last week string
uh I think answer equals get string
quote unquote what's your name just like
in scratch and then down here instead of
doing world I initially wrote answer but
that didn't go well what did I
ultimately do instead to print out hello
David or hello so and so yeah sorry a
little louder yeah so percent s the
so-called format code that printf just
knows how to deal with and I had to add
one other thing someone else besides
percent F
yeah the name of the variable that I
want to plug into that placeholder
percent s and in this case it's answer
now let me make one refinement only
because now we're in week two and we're
going to start writing more lines of
code even though scratch called the
return value of the ask puzzle piece
answer always and see we have full
control over what our variables are
called and now it's probably good not to
just generically always call my variable
answer if I'm using get string let's
call it what it is so this is now just a
matter of style if you will let me
change the variable to be name just so
that it's a little clear to me to you to
a TF or ta exactly what that variable
represents instead of more generically
answer all right so that said let me go
down to my terminal window and last week
again I ran make to compile this exact
same program now though let me go ahead
and just use clang so clang d o I'll
still call this version hello space
hello.c so exact same command as before
the only thing that's different is I've
added a couple of more lines of code to
get the user's input let me hit enter
and now darn it our first error so
output from clang and make is not a good
thing and here we're seeing something
particularly cryptic uh so something in
function main undefined reference to get
string and then Linker command failed
with exit code one so there's actually a
lot of jargon in there that will tease
apart today but my hint is that clearly
my problem's in Maine although that's
not surprising because there's nothing
else going on here get string is an
issue and the uh issue is that it's an
undefined reference and yet notice I was
pretty good I added the cs50 header file
and I said last week that that's enough
to teach the compiler that functions
exist but the problem is that even
though this does in fact teach clang
that get string exists it is not
sufficient information for clang to go
find on the hard drive of the computer
the zeros and ones that actually
Implement get string itself so in other
words this include line per last week is
a little bit of a hint it's a teaser to
CLA that you're about to see and use
this function somewhere but if you
actually want to use the zeros and ones
that cs50 wrote some time ago and bake
those into your program so your program
actually knows how to get input from the
user well then I'm going to have to go
ahead and run a slightly different
command so let me do this let me clear
my terminal window just to get rid of
that distraction and let me propose now
that we run this command instead almost
the same as before clang - o space hello
then hello. C but with one additional
command line argument at the end and
this is a-h L not a number one so- L
cs50 with no space in between those two
now the L is going to result in all of
those zeros and ones that actually were
written by cs50 being linked into your
code your few lines of code or mine here
but that's the second step that the
compiler requires in order to know how
to actually execute and rather compile
your code and cs50's and cs50 is not the
only one that does this if you use any
third-party library in C that doesn't
come with the language you would do- L
such and such where whoever however
they've named their own library but you
don't have to do it for built-in things
like uh like we've been using thus far
all right so let me go ahead and try
this I'll go back to vs code here and
let me go ahead now and run clang - o
hello then hello. C and now instead of
just hitting enter - L cs50 with no
space between the L and the cs50 enter
now nothing bad happens and now I can
do/ hello what's your name I'll type in
David enter and now we see hello David
now honestly this is where we're really
getting into the weeds and now this is
taking this is really just adding new to
the process of compiling and running
your code and so the reality is even
though this is indeed what is happening
this is why we used last week and we're
going to continue using this week onward
make because it just automates that
whole process for you but it's ideal to
understand what's going wrong because
any of the error messages you saw for
problem set one any of the error
messages you see for the next few weeks
probably aren't coming from make they're
coming from clang underneath the hood
because make is just automating the
process but with make you literally just
write make and then the name of the
program you don't have to worry about
any of those command line arguments
questions then on compiling with- l cs50
or anything else
yeah sorry what is the benefit
of what is the benefit of using clang
manually none really in fact all main is
doing is just sa make is doing is saving
us some keystrokes um if you prefer
though and you just like to be more in
control you can totally run clang
manually if you remember the various
command line arguments yeah
exp exactly why did I have to explain
that is provide a hint to cs50 with the
cs50.h henter file but I didn't have to
do that with standard i.h just because
standard i.h comes with C just like a
few other libraries come with C that
we'll start seeing today um cs50 though
is not built into C everywhere and so
you do have to explicitly add that one
there
yeah a command line argument is a a word
or phrase that you type at the command
line AKA your terminal in order to
influence the behavior of a
program for whatever you're doing yeah
it changes the defaults right in our
guey World graphical user interface you
and I would probably click some boxes we
would select some menu options to
configure a program to behave in the
same way at a command line interface you
have to just say everything all at once
and that's why we have command line
arguments
yeah no make is not just for cs50 it's
used globally in any project really
nowadays using C C++ even other
languages as well in fact most every
command you see in this class unless it
has 5 zero at the end of it is globally
used only those suffix with 50 are
indeed course specific and even those
will gradually take training wheels off
of so that you know exactly what those
commands are doing as well all right so
what is it that we've just done
everything we've just done of course I
keep calling compiling but let's just go
down one Rabbit Hole so that you
understand that when you compile code
there's actually a whole bunch of steps
happening and this is going to enable uh
a lot of features like companies can
write code and then convert it to run it
on Macs and PCs alike or phones or the
like so it's not just a matter of
converting source code to machine code
there's actually four steps involved in
what you and I as of last week know as
compiling and these aren't terms that
you'll have to keep in mind constantly
because again we're going to abstract a
lot of this away but just so we've gone
down the rabbit hole once let's consider
each of these four steps that have been
happening for you for a week
automatically uh the first of which is
called pre-processing so what is this
mean well let's consider that same
program as before notice that a two of
the lines of code start with a hash mark
that is a special symbol in C and it's a
so-called pre-processor directive you
don't need to memorize terms like that
but it just means that it's a little
different from every other line and
anything with a hash symbol here should
be pre-processed that is analyzed
initially before anything else happens
so let's consider these two lines up top
what exactly is happening well it turns
out with these two lines you have two
header files of course cs50.h and
standard. i.h where are those files
because they've never been in VSS code
for you seemingly if you type LS if you
open up the file explorer in the GUI you
have never seen probably cs50.h or
standard i.h they just work but that's
because there's a folder somewhere on
the uh the hard drive that you're using
on your Mac or PC or somewhere in the
cloud as in our case and inside of this
folder traditionally called sluser SL
include and user is deliberately
misspelled it's just slightly more
succinct although it's a little weird
why we drop that one letter but user SL
include is just a folder on the server
that contains cs50.h standard i.h and a
bunch of other things as well so in fact
if you type in uh VSS code in your
terminal window uh when you're using
Code spaces in the cloud and type LS
space SL user include you can can see
all of the files in that folder but
we've pre-installed all of that stuff
for you so let's consider what's
actually in those files here where if I
highlight these two lines up top that
start with hash include well I kind of
hinted last week that what's in that
first file is a hint as to what
functions cs50 wrote for you so you can
kind of think of these include lines as
being temporary placeholders for what's
going to become like a global find and
replace that is the first thing clang is
going to do it's pre-process this file
it's going to look for any line that
starts with hash include and if it sees
that it's going to essentially go into
that file like cs50.h and then just copy
and paste the contents of that file
magically there for you you don't see it
visually on the screen but it's
happening behind the scenes and so
really what's happening with this first
line is that somewhere in
cs50.h is the Declaration of get string
like we talked last week and it probably
looks a little something like this and
we didn't spend much time on this yet
this past week but we will in time more
notice that this is how the a function
is declared that is it is decreed to
exist the name of the function of course
is get string inside of the parenthesis
are its arguments in this case there's
one argument to get string I claim today
but you've known this implicitly and
it's a prompt it's the prompt that the
human sees when you use get string what
is that prompt well it's a string of
text like quote unquote what's your name
or anything else that I asked last week
mean meanwhile get string as we know
from last week has a return value it
returns something to you and that too is
a string so again this is also called a
functions prototype it's the thing
toward the end of last week that I just
copied and pasted from the bottom of my
file to the top just so that it was like
this teaser for clang as to what would
exist later so you can think then of
these include lines as just kind of uh
combining all of those function
declarations in some separate file
called cs50.h so that you yourself don't
have to type them every time you use the
library or worse so that you yourself
don't have to copy and paste those lines
this is what clang is doing for you in
its first step of pre-processing second
and last in this example what happens
when clang pre-processes this second
include line well the only other
function we care about in this story is
printf of course which comes with C so
essentially you can think of printf's
prototype or Declaration as just being
this print f is the name of the function
it takes a string that you want to
format like hello comma world or hello
comma percent s and then with dot dot
dot this actually has technical meaning
it means of course that you can plug in
zero variables one variable two or 10 so
dot dot dot means some number of
variables now we haven't talked about
this yet and we won't really in general
print F actually returns a value a
number that is an integer but more on
that perhaps another time it's generally
not something the programmer tends to
look at but that's all we mean by
pre-processing so that the the end of
this process even though there's more
lines of code in cs50.h and standard i.h
what's really just happening is that
clang in pre-processing the file copies
and pastes the contents of those files
into your code so that now your code
knows about everything get string printf
and anything else any questions then on
that first step
pre-processing
yes
good question when you include a file
does it only include what you need or
Does it include everything think of it
as including everything so if it's a big
file that's a lot of code at the very
top and that's why if you think back to
all of the zeros and ones I showed a
little bit ago as well as last week
there's a lot of zeros and ones that end
up on the screen as a result of just
writing hello world a lot of those zeros
and ones are perhaps coming from code
that you didn't actually necessarily
need but some of it is perhaps there but
there are ways to optimize that as well
all right so step two of compiling is
confusingly called compiling it's just
this is the term that most everyone uses
to describe the whole process instead of
just this one step but once a program
has been pre-processed uh behind the
scenes by the compiler for you it looks
now a little something like this and
I've put dot dot dots just to imply that
yes to your question there's more stuff
above it there's more stuff below it
it's just not interesting right now for
us so now we have just C code there's no
more pre-processor directives at this
point all of the hash symbols and those
lines of code have been pre-processed
and convert it to something else and so
now and this is where things get a
little spooky looking uh here now is
what happens when clang or any compiler
literally compiles code like this it
converts it from this in C to this in
assembly code so this is among the
scarier languages I myself don't really
have fond memories this is not language
that many people program in if you take
a subsequent class in computer science
in systems uh a higher level class you
might actually learn this or some
variant there of but there's at least a
few people out there that need to know
this stuff because this is closer to
what the computers themselves nowadays
understand like the Intel CPUs or the
AMD CPUs the brains of today's computers
and phones understand stuff that looks
more like this and less like C now it's
completely uh esoteric but let me just
highlight a few phrases there's some
stuff that's a little familiar there is
mention of Maine at the top there in
yellow there is mention of get string
toward the bottom there is mention of
prf down below so this is just another
programming language called Assembly
Language that decades ago humans myself
included in school did write code in and
absolutely some people still write this
code especially since you can write very
very efficient code but it's a lot more
uh Arcane it's a lot more uh lot less
user friendly so you'll see in Yello now
the these are the so-called instructions
that a computer's brain or CPU
understands pushing values around moving
them subtracting values uh calling
functions and move move move so really
the low-level operations that computers
understand tend to be arithmetic
operations subtraction addition and the
like moving things in and out of memory
it's just a lot more tedious for folks
like us to write code like this this is
why you and I tend to write stuff like
this and ideally still people like you
and I tend to drag and drop puzzle
pieces that sort of abstract all of that
away further but for now this is again
called Assembly Language it is what
happens when the compiler literally
compiles your code but of course this
still not zeros and ones so we got two
steps to go so when a compiler proceeds
to step three this is where things get
converted to machine code and when a
compiler assembles your code for you it
converts what we just saw on the screen
here to actual zeros and ones the
so-called machine code that your phone
or your computer understands but it's
worth noting that these are not
necessarily all of the zeros and ones of
your program yes they re uh they are the
zeros and ones that correspond to your
hello program or printf and get string
and the like but notice that here we
need one final step in those zeros and
ones are only your lines of code but
what about cs50's lines of code that we
wrote to Implement get string what about
the lines of code that humans wrote
decades ago to implement printf those
are somewhere on this hard drive like on
my Mac my PC or somewhere in the cloud
but we need to combine all of those
zeros and ones together and Link My code
with cs50's code with uh standard io's
code all together and so what happens in
the last step ultimately is that if we
have my code here in yellow and then the
code that cs50 wrote and the code that
the authors of C itself wrote what
really is happening is that somewhere we
have not only hello.c which obviously I
wrote and wrote with us live here
there's also let's assume somewhere on
the computer a cs50.c file that
coincidentally I and cs50 staff wrote
years ago and also somewhere on the
computer there's another file Let Me
oversimplify by just calling it standard
io. C in practice it's probably
specifically called print F.C but
there's somewhere these two other files
and so this last step called linking
takes my zeros and ones from the code I
just wrote namely this code on the
screen here it then grabs the zeros and
ones that cs50 wrote and it grabs the
zeros and ones that the authors of C
wrote In order to implement the standard
IO library and lastly voila links them
all together and this is the same blob
of zeros and ones that we saw earlier
it's just now the result of
pre-processing your code compiling your
code assembling your code linking your
code and my God it's at this point like
if there were any fun in programming for
you yet we've just taken it all away we
just call this whole process compiling
why because now that we know those steps
exist and smart people solve that
problem for us you and I can kind of
operate at this level of abstraction and
just assume that compiling converts
source code to machine code questions
though on any of these
intermediate steps
yeah
a good question so where are all of
these zeros in one store because you and
I we've been using a browser at code.
cs50. of course is this web-based user
interface but again recall from last
week even though you're using a web
browser to access VSS code that
web-based version of vs code is
connected to an actual server somewhere
in the cloud and on that server you have
your own account and your own file and
really your own hard drive virtually in
the cloud think of it a little like
Dropbox or box or Google drive or one
drive or something like that so you have
a hard drive somewhere out there that
we've provisioned for you and it's on
that hard drive that we have uh your
code that you just wrote or I just wrote
cs50.c standard I.C and all of the other
code that implements the math functions
and everything else that c
supports good question
yeah
c
good question that uh hash includes
cs50.h line at the top of my code if I
just replace that with the contents of
cs50.c would that work short answer yes
that would work you could copy all of
the code there however there's some
order of operations that might come into
play and so it's probably not quite as
simple as copy paste but conceptually
yes that's what what's happening now
with that said in
cs50.h are only the prototypes of the
functions the hints as to how the
functions look what their return type is
what their name is and what their
arguments are it's in the C file that
actual code tends to be written and this
is a little confusing now because you
and I have only written code in C files
but in the next few weeks you'll
actually start writing some of your own
files as well just like cs50 just like
standard iio but in essence that line of
code just makes it easier to use and
reuse code that's already been written
and that's the whole point of a
library I say that little
louder yes does linking happen when you
compile your code yes when you run make
as we have been doing the past week now
all four of these steps are happening
pre-processing converts the hash include
lines to something else compiling
technically converts it to assembly code
which the Mac the PC the server more
closely understands assembly converts
that language to Binary machine code
that this computer actually understands
and then linking combines everything
together and in fact if you think back a
few minutes ago to when I did this- L
cs50 the reason I had to add that and
the reason my code did not compile at
first was because I forgot to tell clang
to link in cs50's zeros and ones per
that last step I don't need to do- L
standard IO because it comes with c so
that would just be tedious for everyone
in the world but cs50 does not come with
C so we link that in and to be clear too
we won't always use cs50's Library
that'll be yet another pair of training
wheels we take off in the coming weeks
but for now it makes a few things
simpler
yeah short answer yes so what do the
zeros and ones the machine code
translate to yes there is a one toone
relationship between the machine code
and the assembly code assembly code it's
not really English but at least it's
symbols I recognize it's not zeros and
ones machine code of course is just
zeros and ones so back in the day before
c existed people were programming only
in assembly code before assembly code
existed people were coding in zeros and
ones and you can imagine just how
painful that was and so each of these
languages makes life for us sort of
easier and easier in a few weeks we'll
transition to python which will in turn
make C even uh simpler or coding in
general simpler to do to all right so
with that said what now can we uh what
could go wrong with this well it turns
out that besides compiling technically
speaking there's decompiling and we've
not done this and we won't do this but
it's worth considering for just a moment
uh if you were to not compile your code
but decompile it as the word suggests
this just means reversing the process
converting it ideally from machine code
zeros and ones maybe back to C now this
would be cool perhaps if all you have is
a program you can convert it and see the
actual source code what might a downside
be if if anyone on the Internet is able
to decompile code on their machine
yeah okay so it's easier to find bugs in
the code that oh to exploit so it might
be easier to uh hack into the software
by finding mistakes you and I made
because literally they're staring at you
in code worries the zeros and ones make
it way less obvious other downsides of
what I call decompiling
yeah
yeah yeah if your code your work is your
intellectual property copyrighted or
otherwise you know that's kind of
obnoxious that someone can just like run
a command and boom they can see the
original code that you wrote now it
turns out it's not quite as simple as
that and so even though yes you could
take a program like hello or even
Microsoft Word and convert it from zeros
and ones back to some form of source
code be it in C or Java or python or
something else whatever it was
originally written in odds are it's
going to be an utter mess to look look
at why because things like variable
names are not retained in the zeros and
ones typically function names might not
be retained in the zeros and ones the
code is the logic is but the computer
doesn't care what pretty variables you
chose and how nicely named your uh
functions were it just needs to know
them as Z in ones moreover if you think
about last week we introduced things
like loops and c and besides four Loops
there's what other kind of loop for
instance so a while loop and even though
they look different and you have to
write different code they achieve
exactly the same functionality which is
to say when you compile a for Loop or
you compile a while loop if they
logically do the same thing they might
end up looking identical as zeros and
ones and so therefore it's not
necessarily predictable that you'll get
back the original code why cuz because
the zeros and ones might not know so to
speak whether it was a for Loop or a
while loop so maybe decompiling will
show you one or the other and honestly
decompiling while possible and it's one
way of reverse engineering someone's
product odds are if you're good enough
to start reading code that's been
decompiled and reading through the
messiness of it odds are you have the
talent probably to just write that same
program from scratch yourself now that's
an overstatement perhaps but it's not
quite as easy or threatening um as you
might first think so in general once
codee is piled it's pretty challenging
timec consuming costly to reverse
engineer it um much like it would be in
the real world right like all of us have
some kind of phone probably nowadays in
our pocket there's nothing stopping you
from opening it up somehow poking around
recreating what's there that's a huge
amount of effort most likely and at that
point maybe you should just invent the
phone instead of trying to reverse
engineer it so same kind of idea in the
physical world any questions then on
compiling or even decompiling in these
forms
all right so odds are at this point not
only I but you have made mistakes and
you've written buggy code a bug in a
code is just a mistake a logical error
or otherwise where the code just does
not behave correctly as you intend and
up until now odds are your debugging
techniques have been to maybe look back
at what I did in class maybe ask a
question online or in person but
ultimately it'd be nice if you had some
tools of your own with which to debug
code and this honestly is a lifelong
skill you're going to emerge from cs50
and even 20 years from now you're not
going to be writing if you're writing
code at all correct code all of the time
like all of us on the staff continue to
write bugs hopefully they get a little
more sophisticated and not sort of like
oops I missed a semicolon but even those
kinds of mistakes we make too but
there's tools out there and techniques
that can make your life easier when it
comes to solving those problems now the
term bug has actually been around for
decades but a fun story to tell is that
the first documented actual bug was
actually somehow connected to Harvard in
fact this is the log book relating to
the Harvard Mark 2 computer from 1947
whereby if you read the notes here and
if I zoom in this was an actual moth
discovered inside of this big Mainframe
computer that was causing some kind of
problems and the engineers at the time
actually thought it was funny that wow
physical bug actually explains the issue
and it's been forever uh taped to the
sheet of paper which I believe now is on
display in the Smithsonian uh with that
said this is just represented two of a
logical bug and that story is actually
uh that story was often retold by a
famous mathematician then computer
scientist really uh Dr Grace Hopper who
actually worked not only on the Harvard
Mark 2 computer but its predecessor the
Harvard Mark 1 and if you ever spent
time yet in the engineering building
across the river here you can actually
see much of this computer which is along
the wall when you first walk into the
science and engineering complex and
indeed as you've probably heard growing
up this is a Mainframe computer like
this is what Macs and PCs so to speak
looked like back in the day with very
physical things that essentially
implemented the zeros and ones that you
and I take for granted now being
miniaturized in our laptops and phones
so there's a piece of history there if
you visit campus that side of Campus
sometime do take a look but let's
consider then how we solve not of course
physical bugs but logical bugs and let's
consider something like this from last
week whereby we were trying very simply
to print like this uh column of three
bricks using hashtags of sorts so let me
go over here in just a moment to VSS
code and I'm going to go ahead and open
a program I wrote in advance and I'm
bringing it to class because there's a
bug in it and I'd like to figure out how
to solve this bug so let me open up uh
buggy z.c which is version zero of my
code and let's just take a quick peek at
what's here it's pretty short it
includes only standard i.h it uses
printf it uses a for Loop and the goal
quite simply is to print out that column
of three bricks now it's short enough
that some of you if you're getting comfy
already with see you might already see
The Logical bug it's not a syntax error
like it will compile and run but there's
a bug there and suppose that I'm very
new to see I'm very uncomfortable with C
it's 2 a.m. and I just can't see the bug
what are my recourses here for actually
finding a mistake like this well first
let's look at the symptom let me go down
to my terminal window I'm going to use
make buggy zero because again the file
is called buggy zero. C I'm not going to
use clang in fact I'm never really going
to use clang manually here and out I'm
just going to use make because it makes
our lives easier it does compile no
errors so it's not syntax it's not
something silly like a missing semicolon
but when I runbuggy Z I of course see 1
2 3 4 and this of course does not match
the zero the one two three bricks that I
actually intended for that column and
yet I'm starting counting at zero as I
usually do I've got three I'm going up
to three so where is my logical error if
it hasn't obviously jumped out at you
already well how can I solve this well
first and foremost perhaps the best
technique for solving bugs at least
early on is just use printf like thus
far we've used printf to say hello and
other things on the screen but print def
is just a function for printing anything
and there's no reason you can't
temporarily use print def to like print
out the contents of variables what's
going on inside of your program just to
figure out where your mistake is and
then you can delete that line of code
later it doesn't have to stay there
forever so let me do this instead of
just printing out in vs code the hash
symbol let me do a little safety check
here and print out the value of I so let
me go ahead and say something like I is
now I want to say I is this but of
course this is not how I print out the
value of I if I want to print out the
value of I what should I put
here so percent I for integer instead of
percent s for string so they're still
placeholders but we use percent s for
integers and now if I want to print out
I I just need the comma as the second
argument and then I all right let me go
ahead and back to vs uh to my terminal
window let me recompile the program
because I've changed it that still works
fine do/ bugy Z and now let me increase
the size of my terminal window here you
just see some diagnostic information if
you will like this is not the goal this
is not what you should be submitting for
this homework problem we're at one uh
but it is helping us diagnostically know
that okay when I is zero here's a hash
when I is one here's a hash when I is
two here's a hash when I is three here's
a hash well wait a minute that's one two
three four so clearly I'm printing it
one too many times so let me look back
at the code here by shrinking my
terminal window and let me just ask the
group where is in fact the mistake or
what equivalently would be the solution
yeah in the
middle yeah instead of less than or
equal to use just less than so you got
to kind of pick a lane here like if
you're going to start counting from zero
you generally use less than and go up to
but not through the value or if you
prefer like in the human world counting
from one on up you can use great less
than or equal to but you have to be
consistent and in general as a
programmer just always start counting
from zero if you're doing something
canonical like this but the solution is
indeed just to change this by changing
the greater less than or equal to to
less than if I re compile this program
with make buggy zero and then do buggy
zero again and let me increase the size
of my terminal window now you see okay
almost the same output but indeed I
starts at zero goes up two but not
through three all right so printf in
short should be can be your first uh
diagnostic tool instead of just staring
at the screen or raising your hand I
mean use printf to see literally what's
going on inside of your program by just
printing out things of interest and then
once you've solved the problem you can
go back into your code AS I'll do here
by shrinking my terminal window I'll
delete the print F line and now I'm
ready to share this program with the
world or submit it as homework or the
like it's just meant there to be
temporary any questions on printf as a
debugging
tool no all right well that only gets us
so far and honestly as your programs
grow and grow and grow it's going to
actually get really annoying to start
going in and adding printfs then
removing them and figuring out if you've
got multiple printfs well which one
printed what like it just gets messy
eventually to rely on printf alone so
being a computer scientist computer
scientists have written software to make
it easier to debug code that software is
what we would generally call a debugger
which would be the second tool of the
trade that you can use to actually solve
problems in your code now in the world
of VSS code there's actually a debugger
built in so the graphical user interface
you're about to see in VSS code isn't
specific to cs50 it actually comes with
vs code and it supports C and C++ and
Java and Python and lots of other
languages too but it's admittedly a
little complicated to just start using
the debugger you have to like create a
configuration file and do like some
annoying steps that just get in the way
of solving real problems so we have
automated the process for you of just
starting the debugger and thereafter
it's sort of Industry standard how you
use it but we save you the headache of
having to create those configuration
files so suppose I want to do this
suppose I want to try to debug this
program step by step using special
software well how can I do that well let
me propose that if I revert this back to
the original version where I was less
than or equal to three I'm pretty sure
that I was printing to hashes so I'm
going to do this and you might have done
this accidentally or never at all but
notice if you hover over the gutter so
to speak in vs code the part of it all
the way to the left of the editor you
see this sort of grayed out uh Red Dot
if you click there it becomes a brighter
Red Dot and this represents what we're
going to call a break point and this is
just a visual indicator that you've put
like a stop sign equivalent there and
you're telling the debugger in a moment
stop running my code there why because I
prefer to step through my code at sort
of a human speed and not as computer
speed where it runs all at once so I've
set my breakpoint which is step one and
then step two is quite simply this
instead of running the program itself
run a command called debug 50 and then
do/ bugy Z and now this will start your
program but inside of the debugger which
is a special program that smart people
wrote that will Empower you to now step
through your code line by line at again
at your own Comfort Pace I'm going to
hit enter some stuff's going to happen
on the screen whoops uh notice this is a
common mistake that I made accidentally
here looks like I've changed my code I
did because I went in and changed the
less than or equal to sign so let me go
ahead and rerun make buggy zero enter
good now let me rerun debug 50 enter and
now some stuff just happened on the
screen and it takes a moment to get
started but once it's started you'll see
this you'll still see your code but
you'll see this yellow highlight which
you've probably not seen before and
notice that it's specifically
highlighted in the same line that I set
a breakpoint on why that just means the
program has EXE the debugger has
executed all of these lines except for
line seven it has broken at not in a bad
way but it has paused execution on line
seven so it hasn't yet printed any
hashes and you can see that no hashes in
the terminal window yet it's paused
execution but what's interesting with
the debugger is the stuff over here on
the left hand side in the debugger here
you'll see under variables all of your
so-called local variables and we haven't
really made a distinction between local
and something called Global but for now
local variables just means all of the
variables that exist in your function so
I currently has a value of zero okay and
that makes sense so now how do I step
through my code and see what it's doing
well at the top of the screen here
you'll see some playback icons kind of
like a video player but they have
special meaning this first one will just
play the rest of your program all the
way to the end so you only click that if
you sort of solved a problem and you
just want to run run it to completion
like before but the next three or next
two really are really the juiciest the
second one here if you hover over it
eventually you'll see that it's called
step over step over means that the
debugger will run this currently
highlighted line of code but it's not
going to dive into it so if it's a
function like print F it's not going to
start stepping through print F line by
line why because I can pretty much
assume print F written decades ago is
correct problems probably with me but
this next line if I did really want to
step in into the printf code to figure
out how it works or find some problem in
it all these years later you can step
into printf and then the screen would
change and you'd see each of the lines
for print F line by line at least if you
have the source code for print F
installed all right I'm going to use the
first one step over and watch as the
yellow highlight moves and watch as in
the terminal window there's a hash
symbol here we go there's one hash now
notice line five is highlighted that
means it has paused on line five line
five has not yet been exec executed so
what does that mean the value of I per
the top left hand corner is still zero
but as soon as I click step over again
Watch What Happens at the top left where
I is a variable on the
screen now I and it flashed briefly has
a value of one and now if I step over
again watch the terminal window there's
my second hash now let me click step
over on the for Loop watch the variable
at top left now one goes to two now let
me click it again third hash and Here's
Where The Logical error is perhaps
revealed let me go ahead and step over
the loop now I is three wait a minute
I'm still going to print out a hash
there it is there's the fourth hash and
at this point hopefully the light bulb
proverbially has gone off I realize oh I
screwed up I can either stop the program
Al together with the red square or I can
just let it run all the way to the end
which just terminates everything at this
point I just want to get back into my
code and start fixing things and you can
close for instance as I will here the
file explorer just to hide the panel
that open so that's debug 50 but it's
not a cs50 thing that just starts the
debugger for you which is something
you'd find in most any programming
environment nowadays questions on
debugging questions
yeah good question where does it tell
you where it went wrong so sadly it does
not tell you any of that the onus is
still on you the human to use this tool
productively to walk through your code
at a a saner pace but your brain is is
the one that still needs to solve it and
I don't doubt down the line with
artificial intelligence and more
programs like this will get all the more
helpful and start answering questions
like that for us and there are other
tools we'll introduce you this semester
that are even more powerful than this
but for now it's just a tool really to
slow things down and not have to change
your code the fact that I had that panel
on the left that just showed me eyes
changing value is just an alternative to
print F and I can step through it a
little more slowly other questions on
debugging now let me show you one final
example with this debugger here and this
one too I wrote in advance let me close
buggy z.c and let me open up buggy1.c my
second version thereof let me close my
terminal window for a second and give
you a quick tour of this program which
similarly has a mistake now at the top
of this program some familiar includes
cs50.h and standard i.h this is not
something we've seen before it's
specific to this example a function
called get Negative int takes no
arguments and it returns an integer what
does it do it literally gets a negative
integer ideally from the user fun fact
though it doesn't correctly that's the
bug get Negative int is broken at the
moment so what does Maine do well main
just calls this function passing in
nothing in parenthesis no inputs and it
stores the return value in I and then it
just prints out I on the screen so
honestly just by eyeballing this you
know I feel comfortable enough with
programming and see I think main is
correct let me just stipulate main is
correct but there is going to be a bug
down here now what's the bug down here
here well let me look at get Negative in
implementation notice this first line 12
is identical to the Prototype up here
the Prototype is sort of stupidly
required up here because C reads things
top to bottom left to right the compiler
technically does so if you reference get
Negative in here but you don't implement
it until down here and you haven't told
C in advance that it will exist again
you get the error we saw last week all
right so how does get Negative int work
we declare a variable called n
we've got a do while loop that does what
it uses get int which comes with the
cs50 library per last week it prompts
the user for negative integer quote
unquote and stores the value in n i then
do all of this while n is less than zero
right remember we used a do while loop
last week to make sure the human
cooperates and doesn't give us the wrong
type of value be it positive or negative
or something else and then we return n
and there's some subtleties anyone
recall or have an intuition for why I've
declared clared in on line 14 instead of
on line 17 this is a c specific
thing exactly there's this notion of
scope in see and we'll continue to see
this over time whereby a variable only
exists inside of the most recent curly
braces that you've opened so if I've
declared and here on line 14 I can use
it anywhere between lines 13 and 21
because those are the nearest curly
Braes if by contrast as you note if I
instead said this int n equals get int
and so forth and didn't have the current
line 14 well n would exist inside of
these curly braces but not here which is
too late and definitely not here so you
just have to declare it first and then
use and reuse it as such now let me just
show you how I can debug this but let me
show you the symptoms first let me open
my terminal window let me run make buggy
one compiles okay so it's not something
silly like a semicolon dots SL buggy one
and I'm asked for a negative integer all
right let me give it negative one
enter well the main function supposed to
print out what I typed but it clearly
didn't it's prompting me again all right
so maybe it'll like -2 no maybe
-3 50 okay so it's definitely broken
right it kind of seems logically to be
doing the opposite now you can perhaps
see why this is happening already these
are deliberately simple programs by uh
for demonstration sake but let's do this
let me go ahead and set a break point in
main even though I'm pretty sure main is
correct but it just helps me start my
thought process start with Main and then
take it from there let me run now uh
debug
50 bugy one enter and let's see with
that breakpoint now the the goey is
going to reconfigure itself it's going
to pause on line eight because that's
the first interesting line inside of
Maine so I could have just put the
breakpoint on line eight too it's smart
enough to know that if I set it on six
eh you really mean line eight because
that's the first actual line of code and
watch when now what happens if I step
over this line notice that I which at
the moment seems to have a default value
of zero more on that another time but if
I click step over like before I'm
prompted for a negative integer let me
type negative 1 enter and now
notice there's no additional yellow
highlight why where am I currently stuck
logically yeah just logically I must be
in that D while Loop and even if you
don't understand it like that's the only
explanation if you keep getting prompted
surely there's a loop going on there's
only one Loop in my code so there's
probably a problem there so okay I can't
just set a breakpoint in Main and then
wait for this to work so let me just uh
let me stop this with the red square and
let me think all right instead of I can
still set my break point in main but let
me rerun the debugger instead and this
time not step over that line of code let
me step into that line of code so Watch
What Happens now instead of clicking the
second icon here let me click the third
whose name is indeed step into and watch
as the yellow highlight does not move to
line n it dives into line8 the function
on line eight thereby bringing me whoosh
down to line 17 it's kind of going down
into that next function now it didn't
bother pausing on line 12 or 13 or 14
because there's nothing intellectually
interesting there happening yet the
juicy part really starts it would seem
in line 17 so now notice n is my
variable at the top left if I click I
don't want to click step into now
though what what would go wrong if I
click on step into or what would it do
that I don't think I want to
do
yeah yeah it would step into get int but
I'd like to think that the staff's
version of get in is correct and that's
not our problem today so I want to step
over it and watch now at top left that
nothing happens yet to the value of n
until I go to the terminal window now
and type in something like Nega 1 now
notice it jumps to line 19 which is the
next interesting line top left n indeed
is1 and here's where I can now pause as
a human and think all right so while n
is less than zero all right n per the
top left corner is negative 1 so all
right while negative 1 is less than zero
well obviously that's true
mathematically so what's going to happen
it's a do while loop so when I click on
step over again it's going to go to this
line cuz it's at the end of the inside
of that Loop and now here it's looping
through again and again all right let me
do this once more I'm going to step over
all right I'm going to type in -2 and
it's the exact same thing now is my
chance on the yellow line okay wait a
minute -2 is obviously less than zero
let me try this one more time click it
once here and now all right let me give
it 50 and now okay while 50 is less than
zero that's not true so the loop is over
because it's not going to do it while 50
is less than zero that's not true so now
watch when I click step over once more
it then finishes the loop even though
there's nothing more to do it's now
about to return n it jumps back up to
main where I left off on line nine it
now prints in my terminal window the
number 50 and hopefully at this point to
your question earlier my human brain has
realized oh I'm an idiot like I flipped
my my sign there so I probably let me
stop this I probably want to do
something like this if the goal is to
get a negative integer I probably want
to say well n is for instance greater
than or equal to zero would work so
while n is greater than or equal to zero
keep doing this and that's the logic I
wanted to express so the debugger just
saves me from staring at the screen
raising a hand sort of asking someone
else at least in this case it allows me
to go through it at a healthier Pace
questions now on debug 50 which should
be your new friend even if it's not your
first instinct after
printf any questions on debug 50 no all
right all right well there's one last
Technique we can equip you with here um
and that is in addition to printf and a
debugger no joke um a rubber duck is
actually a reasonably recommended uh
solution to finding bugs in your code to
your question earlier the duck two is
not going to solve the problem for you
but if you've wondered why this little
guy has been here for so long um there's
this technique has its own Wikipedia
article of called rubber duck debugging
the idea of which is that if you're home
in your dorm room wrestling with some
bug in your code printf didn't quite
reveal the source to you debugger isn't
really helping honestly maybe it would
help to just sound out what problem
you're having similar to going to office
hours talking to a a TA or a professor
just walking through your problems
because in sort of talking to the duck
about you know the fact that you're
doing this while uh n is less than zero
and then if it is I wait a minute I'm an
idiot not just for talking to the rubber
duck you realize hopefully in expressing
yourself literally verbally you probably
will hear with non-zero probability like
some illogic in your statement and just
by sounding things out you'll realize
like oh that's my problem and so frankly
if you have roommates you can also use a
roommate for this but the rubber duck is
just sort of a go-to when your roommates
have no interest in your you know C
problem set talking something through
that um as follow as such and this is an
invaluable technique I admittedly tend
not to do it so much with a rubber duck
but ideally with colleagues human
colleagues but just talking through
things often will help you just realize
oh I said something logical now I can go
back to the code so don't solve problems
by staring at your screen endlessly for
minutes for hours at that point it's
time for a break time to walk away time
to talk to the duck if you've already
exhausted some of those other tools um
as an aside on your way out today at the
end of class we have H clearly plenty of
rubber ducks uh for you um and uh it's
become a thing over the years at least
among some uh to bring the duck with
them when they travel and send us photos
here for instance is uh cs50's rubber
duck debugger AKA ddb for duck debugger
which is a pun on a geekier program
called GDB the ganu debugger which is an
actual piece of software for debugging
this is cs50's debugger uh in the hills
of Puerto Rico uh also here on the sea
uh he made its way to San Francisco here
uh also down by Fisherman's dwarf by the
sea lions if familiar uh here at
Stanford where there's a William Gates
computer science building for computer
science uh down the road in SF at Google
uh and this is the Tre fountain in Rome
and lastly uh the Coliseum so we'll be
curious to see in the coming years where
your duck two travels so that then was
quite a bit why don't we go ahead here
and take a short five minute break no
snacks yet you're welcome to get up or
sit down we'll return in about five all
right so we are back and if the goal
ultimately today is to have a better
understanding of things like strings so
that we can solve problems with text
let's consider some simpler types of
data first how we might represent those
and then see if that doesn't lead us to
a discovery as to like how strings in
just today's modern software is using
things like that so when we talked on
week zero about representation of data
we had different ways of doing it in
terms of binary and decimal and uh unary
even when we started talking about the
same last week in code we started
talking about uh data types instead and
these data types were a way of telling
the computer like do you want an integer
do you want a character do you want a
floating point value like a real number
or even a string as we've seen but it
turns out that computers of course only
have finite amounts of resources your
computer only has a fixed amount of
memory or RAM and that actually has very
real world implications so for instance
here are some of the data types we've
seen thus far and it turns out that each
of these in C has a specific number of
bits allocated to it now admittedly this
can vary by System it's not so much the
case nowaday days but for many years for
decades computers were getting better
and better the earliest computers might
have used fewer bits for some of these
data types more modern computers might
use more bits so the numbers you're
about to see are pretty much where we
are present day so when it comes to
these data types A bu which is true or
false somewhat curiously uses a whole
bite even though that's way Overkill
because for a bull true or false you of
course only need one bit but it turns
out even though it's wasteful to use
eight bits or one bite just to represent
true or false it's just easier for
computers so a bull tends to be one bite
an INT which we've been using a lot uses
four bytes typically or 32 bits and if I
do some quick math from week zero with
32 bits you have four billion possible
values roughly but if you want to
represent positive and negative that
means you can represent roughly -2
billion all the way up to positive2
billion so that's the range typically
within if that's to few numbers for you
turns out there's things called Longs
and longs use 64 bits which allow you to
have like a quintilian number of
possibilities which is a lot certainly a
lot more than 4 billion so sometimes you
might use a long but even that's finite
and so uh as we discussed at the end of
last week bad things can happen if you
make certain assumptions as the data
because of things like Inger overflow or
the like where things wrap around then
there's a float which is a real number
something with a decimal point by
convention it's four bytes or 32 bits
which gives you in short only a specific
amount of precision it doesn't
necessarily dictate how many numbers to
the left or to the right in the
aggregate ultimately you have though uh
three uh 4 billion possible permutations
still if you need more Precision for
scientific for medical for financial
applications you might use eight bytes
AKA a double which just gives you more
digits of precision they eventually get
imprecise per the example we looked at
last week but it at least gets you
further down the line as an aside in
really really important applications in
finance and medicine and Military
operations and the like where you really
can't have rounding errors long story
short humans have developed libraries in
C and other languages that use more even
than 8 bytes so there are solutions to
these problems but they're always finite
you have to pick uh an upper bound then
there's Char which we saw briefly last
week when I asked the user for y or n
for yes or no and then there's string
which I'm going to propose as a question
mark because a string totally depends
like high h i exclamation point would
seem to be three bytes d a ID would seem
to be five so strings clearly are
variable based on what you or the human
type in so we'll see what this means
though in just a bit this though is the
thing inside of your Mac your PC your
phone might not look exactly like this
but this is a a memory module for a
modern computer and let's go ahead and
use this really as just representative
of the finite amount of memory that any
computer indeed has let's zoom in on one
of these little black chips on the uh uh
circuit board here zoom in and let me
propose that this rectangle really
represents some number of bytes like
tucked inside of this little black uh
circuit on the board is maybe I don't
know a gigabyte a billion bytes maybe
it's a 100 btes some number of bytes it
totally depends on the computer and how
much you paid for the Stick of memory
but if there's a finite number of bytes
physically implemented somehow digitally
inside of this Hardware well then it
stands to reason that we could number
those bytes we can just arbitrarily
decide that the top left corner is bite
number one or really bite number zero
the one next to it is number one then
number two number three dot dot dot
number two billion or whatever it is
however big this this memory is so if
you are use a variable in a c program
that's only one bite like a Char it
might literally be stored in that top
left hand corner of the memory like in
practice you don't care where physically
it is but really the artist rendition
would be this a Char might use one of
those single btes somewhere in the
computer's memory if you use an INT
which is four bytes it would give you
four bytes contiguous that is left to
right top to bottom but all 32 bits
would be next to each other so the
computer knows that those indeed all
belong to the same int if you need a
long or a double for that matter then
you might use a full eight bytes in this
case and you just keep using and using
this memory kind of like a a canvas you
know almost in Photoshop or a
spreadsheet where you can just move uh
pixels or you can move data around
that's really what your computer's
memory is a canvas for storing uh
information in units of bytes or 8 Bits
now we don't need to keep looking at
these circuit boards can abstract it
away as we often do and let's go ahead
and zoom in on this grid just to
consider some very specific variables so
let me zoom in and now I see fewer but
larger uh boxes on the screen Each of
which again represents a bite and now
let me propose that we play with some
actual code so here in C albeit without
a full program or three ins score one
score two score three I have
coincidentally given myself two uh uh
two scores at around 72 and 73 and then
a pretty low score at 33 of course
course last week or two weeks ago this
would have been high but now we're
dealing with actual integers so these
are three so so scores on my quizzes or
tests or the like so let me go to vs
code here and let's make a program
called scores. C so I'm going to write
code scores. C that's going to give me
my new file and let me go ahead and
Implement something like this include
standard i.h int main void and then
inside of here let me do int score one
will be 72 uh int score two be 73 and
int score three will be 33 and then let
me just do something like write a
program to average my three test scores
together something like that so let me
do print F quote unquote my average is
and I'm going to go ahead and do say
percent I back sln and now let me plug
in the results and this is kind of grade
school math now how do I compute the
average of three values well just like
in on paper I can do score one plus
score two plus score three in
parentheses because of order of
operations divided by three since
there's three total scores all right so
I think this checks out and indeed you
can use parentheses and operators like
plus and your code like this in C let me
go ahead now and do make scores no
syntax error so that's good nothing
missing there and now let me do dot
scores and see what my test average is
all right you know it's not great but I
I I think I still passed and indeed my
average here is is 59 is it precisely 59
though well let's see let's let's
actually instead of using an INT how
about we go ahead and use something like
a floating point value here and let me
go ahead and do this so let me recompile
my code make scores huh all right I've
got an issue let me zoom in on my
terminal window we've not seen this one
necessarily before but error on line
nine format specifies type double which
is a lot of precision but the argument
has Type in so what does this mean well
it's showing me with these green
squigglies that something's bad between
the percent F and this thing over here
well on the left I'm implying a float or
a double for that matter on the right
though what data type are score one
score two score three all right so
they're ins so Cent does not like this
the compiler just doesn't like that I'm
using ins on the right but I want floats
on the left so there's going to be
different ways of solving this one way
would be to just ignore the problem like
I originally did and just go back to
percent I or as an aside percent D is
often an alternative to percent I for a
decimal number but we use perc I cuz it
sounds like int so percent I is fine
here too but I don't want to just avoid
the problem I want to actually display a
floating point value so how can I fix
this well it turns out I can solve this
in a few different ways the simplest is
just to make sure that at least one
number on the right is a floating point
value like
3.0 instead of just three now I think
clang will be happier let me do make
scores enter and indeed it's okay why as
soon as you have at least one more
precise data data type on the right it
just treats everything at that point as
floating point value so that the math
works out so/ scores enter and now there
we go right you know uh some of us might
really want that third of a point our
average was not 59 it's 59 and a third
as in this case here all right so we've
solved that there as an aside though
there's one other technique to uh to
show here if you didn't want to change
it to 3.0 because that's a little weird
because I there were literally three
scores it's not like that needs to have
a decimal point you could also
explicitly convert the three to a float
by saying in parentheses float this is
what's called type casting and this will
just convert the thing right after it to
that data type if it's possible so if I
do this again make scores no errors now
do/ scores and I get in fact the same
result there's a bit of a rounding issue
here but we know the rounding relates to
the imprecision from last week for now
let me just be happy with my 59.3
something I'll take that for now but
this is you know is close to um a good
enough correct answer for me now but how
do I think about now what's going on
inside of the computer's memory well
let's consider here's that same grid of
memory each box represents a bite where
are score one score two and score three
in my memory well score one let me just
propose is at the top left but it's
taking up four boxes for four bytes
score two probably ends up right next to
it in memory though this isn't always
going to be the case but I've chosen
simple examples 73 is next to it also
taking up four bytes and then lastly 33
is in score three uh down there
underneath now if we don't if we really
look at the computer's memory look at it
with some kind of microscope or the like
there's actually 32 bits 32 bits 32 bits
in each of those four uh groups of four
bytes representing those values but
again for today's purposes onwards we
don't really need to think again and
again in binary it's just indeed these
decimal numbers being stored there but I
claim now this isn't the best design
even if if you have never programmed
before cs50 what you're looking at here
on the screen as an excerpt in what
sense is this perhaps bad design even
though it's a correct way of storing
three test
scores what's kind of bad here
yeah yeah always do exactly what you did
extrapolate to four scores five scores
50 scores this can't be that welld
designed because now you're going to
have four lines of code five lines of
code 50 lines of code that are almost
identical except for this like arbitrary
number that we're updating at the end of
the variable so indeed there's probably
going to be a better way even though at
least in C we haven't yet seen that
technique but the solution today onward
is going to be something called an array
an array is a uh way of storing your
data back to back to back in the
computer's memory in such a way that you
can access each individual member easily
put another way with an array you can
instead do something like this instead
of saying int score one int score 2 in
score three giving each a value you can
first tell the computer please give me a
variable called scores plural that you
can call it anything you want of size
three Each of which will be an integer
that is to say this is how you declare
an array in C that will have enough room
to store three integers put another way
this is the technical way of telling the
computer please give me uh 12 bytes in
total
3 * 4 each for an inch so give me 12
bytes in total and what the computer
will do is guarantee that they're back
to back to back in the computer's memory
and that'll be useful in just a moment
so let me go ahead and do something
useful with this let me store three
actual scores here's how I could now
store those same numeric scores in this
array syntax is a little different but
there's one variable called scores but
if you want to go to its first location
starting today you use square brackets
and go to location zero first which
because things in C are zero indexed uh
so to speak you start counting at zero
the first int is at bracket zero second
int is at bracket 1 third int is at
bracket two so it's not 1 two three it's
literally 0 one2 and this is not
something you have control over you must
start at zero so these lines now create
an array of size three and then insert
one two three values into that array but
the upside now is that you only have one
name of the variable to remember it's
just called scores yes you need to go
into the array to get individual values
you need to index into it using those
square brackets but at least you don't
have this hackish approach of declaring
a separate variable for each and every
one of these values so let me go back to
scores do c here and let me propose that
I do this let me just kind of use that
same idea to do the following let me get
rid of these three separate integers let
me give myself an INT scores array of
size three and then scores bracket Z
will as before be 72 scores bracket 1
will be 73 and scores bracket 2 will be
33 and let me get rid of the Little Dot
there all right so now if I go ahead and
run this again with make uh scores
enter huh what did I do wrong here I
think I got a little too ahead of myself
let me increase my terminal
window let's focus on line 10 here first
error use of Undeclared identifier score
one what did I do here that was dumb
yeah right so I didn't declare score one
I've got old code right so I just kind
of honestly got ahead of myself here not
even intentionally so let me go ahead
and Shrink my terminal window again I
need to finish my thought here so let me
clear my terminal and let me change this
now to be scores brackets zero plus
scores bracket 1 plus scores bracket two
so it's a little more verbose because
I've got these these um square brackets
so to speak but I think now my code is
consistent so let me make scores now now
compiles do/ scores gives me indeed the
same rough average with those same
values all right so let me go ahead and
maybe um tidy enhance this a little bit
it's a little silly to have to write a
special program just to check your
average of three test scores like 72 73
33 why don't I actually make the program
Dynamic and ask the human for that
average uh for those scores so instead
let me do do this how about we get rid
of the 72 and change this to get int and
I'll just prompt the user for a score
let me get rid of the 33 and change 73
and get this to be get int score quote
unquote and then lastly get rid of the
33 and replace it with get int quote
unquote score get int is a cs50 thing
for now so I need to include cs50.h as
always but I think now it's sort of a
better program because now I can compile
it once I can even share it with my
friends and now any of us can average
three scores on some classes test they
don't need to know the code or rewrite
the code just to T type in their scores
so make scores worked scores now I can
type anything I want maybe it's a 72 73
33 still get the same answer or maybe
I'm having a better semester 100 100
maybe 99 and now we get still a pretty
high score there but now it's Dynamic
now you don't need the source code you
don't need to recompile the program it's
just going to work work again and again
but this too let me propose that this
code is correct if I want to get three
scores from the user but these
highlighted lines now 6 through n are
they welld designed would you
say
yeah yeah right this is we can use a
loop is the spoiler here why I mean my
God it's like the same code again and
again and again the only thing that's
changing is the number and you it should
have kind of had some code smell again
because if I keep typing the same thing
again again and again like that's
clearly an opportunity to better design
something so let me do this let me go
ahead and still create my ver my array
of size three and but let me use our old
friend the for Loop for in I equals z i
Less Than 3 I ++ and then in here let me
do scores bracket we haven't seen this
before but any
intuition scores bracket I because that
will use whatever I is be it Z or one or
two in iteration and then I can get an
INT asking the user for score without
having to repeat myself again and again
so hopefully if I didn't make any typos
make scores all good do/ score 72 73 33
and we're back in business but the code
is arguably now better designed because
now I haven't actually uh I haven't
actually hardcoded the scores and I
haven't actually copied and pasted any
of that code well if we consider now
what's going on inside of the computer's
memory it's pretty much the same in
terms of the values but instead of the
variables being literally score one
score two score three there's just one
variable it's an array called scores but
you can index into its three locations
by using scores bracket Z to get the
first scores bracket one to get the
second scores bracket two to get the
third but this is key the memory is
contiguous it's only the screen is only
so large so it wraps around but
physically digitally the memory is
contiguous top to bottom left to right
and that's important why because the
brackets indicate 0 1 2 that each of
these integers is just one integer away
from the next it can't be randomly down
here all of a sudden it's got to be back
to back to back all right now equipped
with that Paradigm what more could we
actually do here well it turns out it's
worth knowing that it's possible in code
to even pass arrays around as arguments
and let me just whip this program up
somewhat quickly just so you've seen it
before long but let me go ahead and do
this let me propose that I create a
function that does this averaging for me
so I'm going to create a function called
average that returns a float uh and the
arguments this thing is going to take uh
let's see it's going to be the array so
it turns out if you want to take in an
array of numbers you can call it
anything you want this is how you tell C
that a function takes not an integer but
in Array of integers and you don't have
to call it array I'm doing that just for
the sake of discussion it can be called
X it can be numbers it can be anything
else I'm just calling an array to be
super explicit as to what it is there
now how do I change my code down here
what I think I'm going to do for the
moment is just this I'm going to get rid
of this code here where I manually
computed the average and let me just
call the average function here by
passing in the whole array of scores so
this is just an example of abstraction
like now I have a fun function called
average I don't care I don't have to
remember how it works once I implement
it it just kind of tightens up my main
code a little bit but I do still have to
implement this so later in my file let
me repeat myself before the only time
it's okay and see to repeat yourself
again and again by typing out again
average and then int array Open Bracket
but now not a semicolon now I have to
implement this thing and I can implement
this in a bunch of different ways uh but
I don't know huh in advance I can't just
do this I can't just do array bracket 0
plus array bracket 1 plus array bracket
2 unless unless this program is only
ever going to work on three numbers so
huh let me let me go ahead and do this
let me first propose that there's a poor
design here in my main function what
value have I repeated
twice among the highlighted lines what
jumps out at use twice L of the array
yeah the length of the array is just
three now it's not a huge deal that I
type the number three on line eight on
line nine but this is exactly the kind
of like shortcut that's going to get you
in trouble eventually why because
eventually you or someone else is going
to go in make the array bigger or
smaller and you're not going to realize
that magically that same number is in
two places and indeed this is what a
programmer would often call a magic
number a magic number is one that just
kind of appears magically and you're on
the honor System to change it here if
you change it here and then you change
it over here like that's not going to
end well if it the onus is on the
programmer to remember where they
hardcoded that is rote out three
explicitly so anytime you reuse a value
like this you know what we should
probably do what we did last week which
was to declare a variable uh perhaps at
the very top of my program so it's super
obvious what it is called maybe n and
set that equal to three better yet what
did I do last week to make sure that I
Can't Screw Up and accidentally change
that value yeah constant and the keyword
there was just const for short and now I
have a global variable Global in the
sense that I can access it anywhere that
is called n it's an INT and it's always
going to be three and now I can improve
my main function a little bit by just
changing the threes to n so now if I if
a colleague realize oh wait a minute
there's four tests this year you change
n to four recompile the code and it just
works everywhere else except in my
average function let me change it back
to three just for consistency this is
not going to fly now to just uh sum up
things like this for instance and then
return this divided three why will this
not work
now as I've defined
it
yeah okay I might be in returning an
integer value when I intend to return a
float per this but I think I'm okay CU I
Ed that little trick where I made sure
that at least one of the numbers in my
my arithmetic expression is in fact a
floating point value and just by adding
the point zero make sure that everything
gets treated as a float so I think
that's
okay sorry a little
ladder exactly so left hand's not
talking to the right hand here and that
my current implementation of average is
still assuming that there's only going
to be three tests or whatever but wait a
minute I just went through the trouble
of modifying this to be n generically
and if I change this to four I'm not
going to be happy perhaps with my
average because now I'm going to ignore
one of my test scores Al together so let
me change this back to three and
unfortunately if it's a variable now n
and therefore I have literally a
variable number of scores how do I take
the average of a variable number of
things I mean what's my building block
there
yeah
yeah why don't I use a loop that goes
through the array and adds things up as
you go I mean kind of like grade school
as you take the average on your
calculator or paper pencil you just keep
adding the numbers together and then you
divide at the End by the total number of
things so how can I do this well let me
change my implementation of average to
First declare a a variable called sum or
whatever set it equal to zero so this is
like me on my piece of paper getting
ready to count or my calculator of
course when you turn it on typically
defaults to zero and now let me do four
in I equals z i is less than a VAR I no
I didn't do that n i is less than n
i++ and now in here let me go ahead and
add to the current sum uh whatever is in
the arrays location I and then down here
I think I can just return sum divided by
3 nope not 3.0 n perhaps here and
actually I think I'm going to get let's
make sure it's a float let's use the the
type casting trick just to make sure I
don't accidentally Short change someone
and uh throw away everything after the
decimal point so it just escalated
quickly right like average just got a
lot more involved it's just not just a
single one line of code but now it's
Dynamic I initialize a variable called
sum to zero in this loop I go through
and just keep adding to sum which is
initially zero whatever is in Array
bracket I or specifically array bracket
zero array bracket one array bracket two
that gives me a total sum that I return
divided by the total number of things
now this I can tighten slightly recall
that this is syntactic sugar for just
adding things I can't use plus plus
because that only literally adds one but
I can use here plus
equals questions on this implementation
here really the only takeaway or the
most important takeaway is that this is
the Syntax for how you tell a function
that to it expects a whole array not a
single variable like an INT or the like
you literally use square brackets but
you don't specify the length inside
there
yeah what about the variable at the
top good question what do I have it
defined as at the top this variable n it
must be an integer if you're going to uh
use it inside of in arrays square
brackets here so this line 10 notice no
longer says three it says n and so
whatever n is three or four or something
else that's how many integers I will get
in that array and it must be by
definition of an array an integer that
goes in those square brackets and here's
a common source of confusion when you
create the array that is declare it you
use square brackets like this where you
put the total number of elements you
want when you subsequently use the array
like I'm doing here you don't mention
int again just like you don't mention in
again and again once a variable exists
you use the square bracket still but you
don't use n you use zero or one or two
or generically here I so when C was
designed they sometimes use the same
Syntax for two different ideas or
contexts
yeah good question do I have to include
line six short answer yes because of the
reason we ran into last week C or clang
really reads your code top to bottom
left to right and so if the compiler
sees some mention of this function
average on line 16 but you haven't told
the compiler that average exists you're
going to get an error on the screen so
the conventional way to do that is you
just copy paste the one first line of
code from the function it's so-called
prototype or Declaration
yeah really good question uh in a
perfect segue is there a library you can
use if you don't know the size of the
array no and so if any of you have
programmed in uh in uh Java or python or
other Lang languages you can actually
just ask the array like how big is it in
C you and I the programmers have to
remember it and so short answer no
there's no function that will just
automatically do this for us and in fact
let me make a more subtle claim that
it's fine to use Global variables like
this if they're really for configuration
options why it's just convenient to put
them at the very top of the file because
everyone you your colleagues your Tas
are going to see them at the top of the
code but you really shouldn't be using
them everywhere throughout your code
it'd be better if the average function
itself we're independent of that special
variable so by that I mean this you know
what I should really do if I really want
to be welld designed I should pass in
the length of the array to the average
function I should give the average
function a second argument I'll call it
length for instance but I could call it
anything I want and so rather than
putting n all the way down here at the
bottom of my file let me just
dynamically say length instead and this
is a subtlety and no need need to get
too tripped up over this but this now is
just an example of how the same function
can take not one but two arguments but
indeed in C you must remember yourself
what the length of an array is you can't
just ask the array via some syntax like
you can those of you who've programmed
before in Java or python
yeah good question would it be better to
write a function that computes the size
short answer can't do that in C as soon
as you pass an array into a function in
C you cannot figure out its size if it's
a generic array like that of integers
there are special cases that uh you can
do that but in general no it's just not
possible in see and if that's some
frustration honestly this is why more
modern languages add that feature why
because it was really annoying um as I'm
alluding here to not having that
information now just to make sure I
didn't screw up anywhere let me compile
this final version of
scores
suspense all good/ scores 72 73 33 and
we're still back in business so this
version is more complicated and as
always we'll have this version on the
course's website for reference but the
point really is that arrays not only can
be used as containers to store multiple
values three or more in this case um you
can also even pass them around as
arguments as such all right now besides
that let's let's simplify for just a
moment and consider now the world of
chars if we've just got single bites
where uh where does this lead us and how
does this get us ultimately to strings
to solve problems like readability and
cryptography and the like well here for
instance are three lines of code out of
context that simply store three chars
and you can already see where this is
going having three variables called C1
C2 C3 is clearly going to end up being
bad design because of all the silly
redundancy here but notice I'm using
single quotes like last week because
these are single chars what does this
look like in the computer's memory well
it looks a little something like this if
we clear out the old memory C1 C2 C3
probably will end up here maybe not
literally in the top leftand Corner this
is just an artist rendition but C1 C2 C3
will probably end up like that now
what's really there it's really those
same three numbers 72 73 33 but how many
bits does a bite
have just eight so if we were to look at
the binary representation of these
characters it would only be eight bits
each that's enough to store small
numbers like 72 73 33 we're not dealing
with Unicode and emoji and the like but
the point is the same you don't have to
use four bytes to store these numbers
you can use a different data type like
chars and underneath the hood it's
indeed going to use just single bytes
for each but this is sort of like a this
isn't really how we Implement strings
right when you wanted to say hi last
week or this we use double quotes and we
wrote all of the things together and
used one variable not three right when I
typed in David I didn't have a variable
for d a v i d i had one variable called
name that stored the whole thing so in C
we keep talking about these things
called strings we'll see eventually that
strings are not necessarily what they
seem to be but for now the key thing
about strings is that they're variable
length uh so to speak right they might
be three characters high or five
characters David or anything uh smaller
or larger so how do we go about
implementing strings if all we have at
the end of the day is my memory well
here is an example of just creating uh
declaring and defining a string called s
s because it's just a simple string and
quote unquote high in double quotes what
does this look like in the computer's
memory well let's clear it again and
here now because it's technically stored
in one variable s here is how I might
draw it as an artist it's three bytes in
total H exclamation point but there's no
C1 C2 C3 it's just the whole thing is uh
s but it turns out that a string fun
fact is really just what underneath the
hood kind of leading up to this what is
a string if this is how it's laid out in
memory literally it's just an array of
characters and we didn't have to know
about arrays last week to use strings
this is where again the training wheels
are starting to come off but a string is
just an array of characters Hi
exclamation point for instance so
technically an array a string called s
is really a variable called s that
allows you to get at the first character
with s bracket zero if you want s
bracket 1 s bracket2 you can literally
get individual characters just by
treating S as though it's an array which
it really is underneath the hood in this
case but there's a catch how do you know
where strings end in the past when I
drew some integers on the screen I know
I claim they always take up four bytes
if I had drawn a long it always takes up
eight bytes if I drawn a a character it
always takes up one bite but how many
bites does a string take up yeah I mean
that's kind of the right answer in this
case three it would seem but if it's
David that's a good five characters but
where do we put the number three where
do you put the number five right this is
literally all that's into your computer
this is all our building blocks in front
of us so how can we where does the three
go where does the five go well it turns
out you can solve this in a couple of
different ways but the way humans
decided to implement strings years ago
is indeed an array but they added one
extra bite at the end of every such
string array just to make clear with a
so-called Sentinel value that the string
ends here why so that if you have two
strings in the computer's memory like hi
and by you know where the barrier is
between like the exclamation point of
one and the letter B in the next right
you need some kind of delimiter and so
what really is underneath the hood is
this when you store a string in memory
when you type in a string as the user if
you type in three characters it's it's
going to use 3 + 1 = 4 bytes in total if
you type in David it's going to use 5 +
1al 6 bytes in total why because C
automatically adds this special zero at
the end of the string I've drawn it with
back SL Zer because this is how you
represent zero as a Char as a character
but this is literally just zero as we'll
soon see so anytime there's a string in
memory it always takes up one more bite
than you yourself as the programmer or
human typed in in fact if we convert
this again just for discussion sake to
those integers what's literally stored
in the computer's memory is going to be
72 73 33 and now a zero and the computer
because of c and how it was invented
it's just smart enough to know that when
you print out a string it prints out
every character until it sees a zero and
then it just stops printing in
particular printf knows how this works
and this is why print F knows when to
stop printing decimal numbers are not
that enlightening we'll generally write
the characters like this and again back
back sl0 is just special symbology like
it's what the programmer types to make
clear that you're not saying hi zero
you're saying hi and then it's a special
zero specifically it is eight zero bits
that indicate that it's the end of the
string technically that back sl0 if you
want to be fancy it's called null
NL and it turns out you've seen this
before that we didn't call it out here's
that same asky chart from the past
couple of weeks if I highlight this what
is decimal number zero mapping to n
which is just programmer speak for the
special null character all zero bits
that means the string ends here this all
happens automatically for you you do not
need to create these null characters or
these
zeros any questions
then on this implementation thus
far any questions here no well let me do
this let me go back to vs code in a
second and let's actually corroborate
this with some code let me go ahead and
create a small program called high. C
and how about we do this let me include
standard i.h let me include uh let me
type out int main void as always and now
let me do something simple and kind of
bad but Char C1 equals quote unquote H
in single quotes Char C2 equals quote
unquote I in single quotes and lastly
Char C3 equals exclamation point in
single quotes and now let me just print
this out I can't use percent s cuz that
is not a string that's literally three
chars cuz that's the design decision I
made but I could do this percent C
percent C percent C which we haven't
seen before but percent s is string
percent I is int percent C is indeed uh
Char so let me put a back sln at the end
for cleanliness and now do C1 C2 C3 so
this is like a Char based version of
printing string so let me make high and
then let me do/ high and it looks like I
use print f with percent s but I did
things very manually by printing out
each individual character what's cool
now though is that once you know that
characters are just numbers and strings
are just characters you can kind of poke
around let me change all three
placeholders to percent i instead and
this is totally fine too let me rerun
this make
High um actually let me make one change
just so we can see this let me add
spaces just for Aesthetics sake let me
do make high do SL High enter and voila
like now you can actually see the
numbers that I claimed back in week zero
were in fact happening underneath the
hood well this is not how you would make
strings it'd be incredibly tedious to
have three variables for threel Words
five variables for five letter words
we've been using of course strings since
last week so let's do that instead uh
string uh s equals quote unquote double
quotes high for this no because of these
training wheels I need to include the
cs50 library but we'll come back to that
in the coming week but for now I'm going
to go ahead and create a string s called
quote unquote high and now I'm going to
change this to be my familiar percent s
and now just print out s itself this of
course is the same thing as last week
high gives me the exact same thing but
now we're dealing of course with strings
but how can we see a little beyond that
well how about this let's poke around
further with today's Primitives even
though s is a string I could technically
print out its first character with
percent C by doing s bracket z i could
technically print out its second
character with percent C by doing s
bracket one I could print out its third
character with percent C and printing
out s bracket 2 so again this just
derives logically from my understanding
now of that strings or arrays as you
note let me do make let me do make high
SL high and no visual change but I'm
just kind of now tinkering around and in
fact if you're really curious let me do
this let me change these back to I back
to I I oops back to I and let me add a
fourth one because if I'm really curious
now let's see it what's S braet 3 this
is the fourth bite and even though the
string itself is hi I think we can
corroborate this whole null thing make
high SL High enter and there it is you
could have done this last week if you
really wanted to geek out on strings but
like for now it's just revealing what's
going on underneath the hood questions
then on what these strings are
yeah why do we need the
bracket uh uh why do you not need
brackets good question why do I not need
brackets on line six uh to because uh s
is a string we'll see in a couple of
weeks that s is essentially implemented
underneath the hood indeed as an array
but that happens automatically for you
you can treat S as just a variable name
without square brackets you will use
square brackets when you have arrays of
ins or you manually create arrays of
chars or doubles or Floats or anything
else but strings are special why I mean
every program you write seems to use
strings text in some form we're humans
we like text not just numbers and and
such so this is just treated a little
specially in C and many other languages
as
well other questions on this here no
let's add then one other string to the
mix so instead of just saying hi why
don't we consider version of the program
that says both high and by and I claim
now that that back sl0 that null
character is going to be ever more
important now if we've got two strings
in memory so that c knows how to
distinguish one from the other so let me
go ahead and just get rid of these two
lines for the moment let me recreate
string s equals quote unquote double
quotes High Let me give myself another
one and because I'm just playing around
I'll choose very short variable names
string T equals quote unquote by
exclamation point and then let me just
print them both out uh let me go ahead
and print out percent s back sln comma s
and then print F percent s uh back sln
and then T so very simple demonstration
of just these two variables make high do
SL high and of course it prints out two
lines one after the other what's
actually going on underneath the hood
well let's go back to the computer's
memory High I think it's going to be I
claim pretty much the same so s I'll
claim is in the top left followed by the
back sl0 and that's important now
because by probably is going to end up
there and Visually it wraps just by
nature of how I've drawn this grid of
bytes but it's continuous B ye
exclamation point null AKA back0 this is
Now helpful to print F because now
printf knows where one begins and ends
by way of that special null character
but we can poke around now too what else
can I do here how about this how about I
go into my code here back to BS code and
let me go ahead and say something like
well if I've got two of these uh strings
you know let's put them in an array
let's kind of do this sort of arrays in
arrays sort of inception style here so
string words bracket two so give me an
array of two strings is what I'm saying
here in code even though we've not done
it with strings yet we only did it with
ins and now let me do this the first
word AKA words bracket zero will equal
as before high and now words bracket one
will equal quote unquote by bite so by
and now I've done the exact same thing
but again I'm just avoiding having s t
QR and like all these different
variables in my code I just now I'm
treating them as one single array of
strings how do I change my code down
here well if I want to print the first
word I do words bracket zero and if I
want to print the second word I do words
bracket one this is not a useful
exercise at the moment because I'm just
making my code more complicated but
again it allows us to post poke around
and see what's going on because there is
that high and by but watch this if I
really want to be cool I can do this
let's print out percent C percent C
percent C back sln and then here percent
C percent C percent C percent C so four
of those and now here's where things get
interesting words is an array of strings
but again if I may what's a
string an array of characters so just
use the same logic if words is an array
of strings you get at the first string
with words bracket zero how do you get
at the first character in the first
string bracket Zer words bracket Z
bracket one and lastly words bracket Z
bracket two and now down here words
bracket one but the first character is
there words bracket one the second
character is here words bracket one the
third character is here whoops third
character is here and words bracket one
one the fourth character is here like
this is not how people program this is
only for demonstration sake my God it's
so tedious and verbose already but if I
make high now do SL high now I'm like
manually Reinventing percent s if I
forgot it existed using percent C alone
but you can indeed manipulate arrays in
this way but because strings are arrays
of characters you can manipulate strings
uh in this way too any question now on
this syntax
any questions here no no all right well
let's go ahead and propose that we solve
a couple of other problems we might not
have as before but first a quick visual
of what's been going on underneath the
hood here if here again is where we left
off on the screen high and by uh back to
back here is really how I just treated
these things s bracket 0123 and then t0
1 2 3 4 but really once I put them in an
array the picture becomes this words Z
is the whole High words bracket one is
the whole by but if I really get into
the weeds and start indexing into
individual characters in those strings
all I'm using is new syntax in order to
represent these same values here
questions then on these
representations before we Forge
ahead no
yeah does the new line character say
that one
more ah really good question does the
new line character take up any space uh
it does when so far as printf is
concerned but I'm not storing the back
slash n in my strings printf is being
manually handed that thing
instead all right so let's go ahead then
and consider how we might solve some
problems that have Arisen now with these
strings as follows here suppose I let's
do this let me go back to VSS code here
and let me go ahead and open up a new
file called how about uh length uh. C
and let's consider for a moment how I
might actually figure out what the
length of a string is which is distinct
from the length of an array I claimed
earlier you cannot figure out
dynamically what the length of an array
is but I can figure out the length of a
string specifically because of this
implementation detail of that null
character so let me go ahead and do this
let me include cs50.h in this second
program here let me include standard i.h
as before and let me do this int main
void and in the first thing I'll do is
just get a string from the user I'll ask
the user as always for their name so
I'll call get string and say what's your
name question mark as always and then
down here if I want to figure out the
length of this string and print the name
the print the length out on the screen
well I can kind of do this similar in
spirit to the average where I'm
accumulating something let me go ahead
and initialize n to zero let me give
myself huh it's not not a for Loop
because I don't have a I don't know in
advance how long it is but what if I do
this
while the value at name bracket n does
not equal single quote back
sl0 crazy syntax at the moment but it's
just the culmination of these various
building blocks let me just finish the
thought here
n++ and then down here let's just print
out with print F and percent I that
value of n
so I claim this is going to show me the
length of any string I type in whether
it's high or by or David or anything
else I initialize a variable to zero and
that's good because that's where you
start counting in general while name
bracket 0 does not equal back0 what is
this saying well if name is the string
the user typed in and name is just an
array as you noted then name bracket
zero is going to be the first character
and I'm asking the question well does
the first character not equal back0 and
if I type in David D is it's not so I
keep going and I add one to n then I'm
going to check name bracket one well if
I typed in David name bracket one is
going to be a a does not equal back0 and
so it's going to go again and again and
again but five steps in total later it's
going to get to the bite after David
realize wait a minute that is a back
slash n the Loop finishes and I print
out the total length arrays in general
do not have this null character however
strings do again strings are special
versus all of the other data types we've
talked about thus far but how could I
for instance uh do this differently well
let's actually Factor this out as a
function as I've I've commonly done but
rather than implement it myself you know
what it turns out what's nice about
strings being so common there are many
other people who have solved these
problems before and in fact there's a
whole string library in C it is used by
way of a header file called string.h and
what string H is is a library of string
related functions in fact you can see in
cs50's manual pages for C uh the
string.h functions at least those that
we recommend as most useful and in
particular if you poke around there
you'll see that there's a function
called Sterling means string length it
was named very succinctly just because
it's a little easier to type than string
length but Sterling tells you the length
of a string so how might I use this in
my code here well it turns out I can
simplify this quite a bit let me get rid
of my Loop get rid of my uh my counting
manually and do something like this int
n equals Sterling of the human's name
name and now I'll just use print f as
before with percent I back sln and
output the value of n but but there's a
bug at the moment what have I forgotten
to
do yeah I have to include the header
file at the top of the screen so let me
at the top of the code so let me also
include string.h at the top of my file
so that c knows that in fact sterl
exists let me go ahead and make length
as
before length uh or actually really for
the first time what's your name David
and hopefully I'm going to see in fact
five by contrast if I run it again and
type in high exclamation point now I see
three so Sterling is just one of the
functions in that library and there's so
many more in fact yet another library
that might be useful moving forward is
this one C
which relates to C data types and lots
of functions therein that can be useful
for instance if you review its
documentation in the manual pages online
you'll see that there are functions via
which we can solve problems like this
let me go ahead and propose here let me
see let's do um example here
involving how about uh checking if
something is uppercase or lowercase and
converting it uh to uppercase only let
me go back to vs code and code a program
called uppercase Doc in this file I'm
going to start by including now as
always
cs50.h I'm going to include standard i.h
and I'm going to add one other to the
mix which is
string.h now2 so I can access the length
of things as needed int main void comes
next and then within my main function
I'm going to go ahead and declare a
string called s I'm going to call get
string as before and I'm going to go
head and just ask the user for a string
called before I want to do it before and
after whatever the user types in is
before but I want to force everything to
uppercase thereafter let me now in this
Loop here do this let me print F quote
unquote after just so we can see this on
the screen and let me do four in I gets
zero I is less than stir Lang of s I ++
what am I about to do I'm about to
iterate over every every character in
the string from left to right from zero
on up two but not through the length of
s and how do I check if something is
lowercase so that I can actually force
it to uppercase well it turns out I
could do this literally if the character
in s at location I is greater than or
equal to Capital a Ampersand Ampersand
which means and instead of or which we
saw in the past s braet i is less than
or equal to little Z that means
logically in English that this is indeed
a lowercase how do I now convert it to
uppercase this character well I could
just literally print out the same
character but that would not be the
answer here because that's not changing
the value but what could I do instead
well let me actually pull up here real
fast the asky chart as before and let's
see if we can't glean some insight if I
pull up the same ask each chart and
suppose the human has typed in a
lowercase a that's
97 what letter I want to convert it to
uppercase a so what number do I want to
convert the 97 to per week zero so 65 we
keep coming back to that one what if the
user types in lowercase B I want to
change the 98 value to 66 and so forth
and any quick math how far part of those
so it's always 32 like uppercase to
lower case is always wonderfully good
design 32 away one from the other so
what does this mean well I think we saw
earlier that underneath the hood a Char
is just a number you can certainly do
arithmetic on it and here again if you
understand these lower level Primitives
what if I do this whatever s bracket I
is if I know on line 13 that it's up
that it's lowercase do I want to add or
subtract
32 so I want to subtract because I want
to go from like 97 to 65 or 98 to 66 so
indeed if you do some quick math that
gives you 32 so it suffices to just
treat chars as numbers subtract the 32
and printing it with percent C I think
will just convert lowercase to uppercase
if you now fast forward to like the real
world Microsoft Word or Google Docs if
you've ever chosen the menu option that
forces things to uppercase or lowercase
on occasion literally that's what
Microsoft and Google have done they
iterate over every character in the
document check if it's lowercase and if
so they subtract 32 from it and show you
the new value what if though it is not a
lowercase letter I think I can keep it
easy and just print out the current
letter unchanged if my goal is to Simply
Force things to all uppercase and that
letter then would be S bracket I so let
me go ahead now and make uppercase
hopefully no errors do/ uppercase and
I'll now now type in David with an
uppercase D but lowercase everything
else but now the after version is David
an aesthetic bug notice here I forgot to
include just for prettiness sake about
back sln at the end no problem I'll add
that let me fix my mistake make
uppercase SL uppercase enter daid enter
and voila and I I deliberately added
another space after the after just so
they would line up pretty even though
before and after have different numbers
of letters questions then on this
implementation of forcing something to
uppercase which in and of itself is not
all that enlightening but is
representative now of how you can
leverage these low-level
Primitives question
now all right well this honestly is
tedious my God like does Microsoft
Google everyone you have to literally
write out this code just to do something
simple well no that's again why we have
things like libraries and increasingly
now for problem sets projects and Beyond
well you just use libraries more often
off the shelf so as to solve problems
that surely other people have had before
you so how can I now use this uh Library
ctype.h well let me go back into my code
let me include this among my header
files here I tend just so I can skim
things easily I tend to alphabetize my
headers but that's not strictly
necessary but it allows me at a glance
to realize did I or did I not include
something I need now let me go ahead and
do this it turns out if you read the
documentation for the ctype library
there is a function wonderfully called
if is lower that takes in a character as
its argument essentially so s bracket I
and if that returns true a Boolean value
if you will well I'm going to force it
to lowercase but I don't have to do this
this math anymore turns out in the ctype
library there's also a function called
two upper that takes a character as
input like s bracket I and it just does
the math for you so that you can
abstract away the 32 thing and just know
that someone else has solved that
problem for you otherwise I can leave my
code unchanged down below because I'm
not changing anything else so if I do
make uppercase now and then do SL
uppercase daavid with just a capital D
and now it still works but if you read
the documentation further it turns out
that two upper is smart if you pass in a
character to two upper that's lowercase
it obviously converts its uppercase by
doing that math but if you pass in a
character to to Upper that's already
uppercase the documentation you would
see tells you that it leaves it
unchanged so I can tighten all of this
up I can get rid of the whole else I can
get rid of the whole if and arguably now
Implement a program that's just as
correct but better designed why fewer
lines of code easier to read Le lower
probability of mistakes assuming the
library is correct it just makes it
easier and faster for me now to write
code so if I now do one last time make
uppercase enter uppercase and type in my
name still working but now notice we've
whittel this down to far fewer lines of
code albeit using now this additional
Library questions then on how we did
this no well even even though this code
I dare say is correct it's not
necessarily welld designed just yet in
fact there's one line of code one
function call in this current
implementation that's more inefficient
than it needs to be and allow me to draw
our attention to this here line 10
wherein we're calling Sterling but we're
calling it inside of this for Loop
specifically inside of the condition and
why might that not necessarily be the
best
idea well is the length of the string s
changing ever I mean certainly not
within the span of this Loop and so here
we are within our for loop on line 10 11
12 and 13 asking on every iteration that
same question what's the length of s
what's the length of s what's the length
of s and in turn we're calling Sterling
every time even though we're getting
back the same answer so I dare say a
better solution here would be to maybe
figure out the length of s earlier on in
my code and maybe declare a variable or
perhaps do something that's
syntactically a little more elegant and
in fact a very common design in Loop
like this would be to declare not just
one variable like I but to actually
declare a second variable called n for
instance where n is just some number Set
n equal to the length of s but
thereafter inside of this condition
instead of calling Sterling of s again
and again and again what might I now do
I could instead just compare I against n
itself because n now will only be
calculated once when it's initialized
just as I is initialized to zero and
thereafter we're going to be compar
comparing I which is changing against n
which will not be so it's going to be
marginally more efficient by Design now
with that said a good compiler could
also recognize that there was this
optimization possibility and maybe do it
for us but for now best to get into the
Habit best to develop the muscle memory
for making those better design decisions
yourselves questions then on how we did
this no all right a few final building
blocks for the day so we started by
talking about those command line
arguments that clang uses whereby
anything after the command that you type
at a prompt be it make or clang or even
CD in Linux any word thereafter or
something cryptic like- O is a
commandline argument it's an input to
the command it's different from a
function argument because a function
argument of course is an input to a
function but it's the same idea it's
just different syntax after the dollar
sign at the prompt well it turns out
that command line arguments are
something you can now use in your own
programs by
accessing uh words after the prompt and
let me propose that we invent we invent
this as follows let me propose that we
switch back to vs code here and I'll
open a new file here called greet doc so
in greet Doc is going to be a program
that very simply greets the user had we
written this last week we would have
done this include
cs50.h and then include uh standard
i.h and then int main void and then we
might do something simple like string
name equals get string quote unquote
what's your name question mark and then
we would have printed out as always
hello comma percent s and then plugging
in that name so this is the same program
we've implemented many times just to
make sure it works although nope that's
not quite the same program semicolon in
the wrong place this now is the same
program so make greet /g greet and I'll
type in my own name hello David so we're
back there now what's arguably a little
Annoying about this program if I type in
something else like Carter enter you
know I have to run the program wait for
the prompt type in my name hit enter and
that's fine but imagine if every program
worked like this like make suppose you
could only type make then you wait for a
prompt then you type the name of the
program you want to make then you hit
enter or worse in Linux when you have to
change directories as you might have for
problem set one what if you had to type
CD enter now type the name of the folder
you want to change into enter I mean it
just slows life down and so it just gets
annoying quickly so commandline
arguments just let you express your
whole thought all at once so how can I
do this well if I want to express the
notion of command line arguments in my
code I could do something like this I
could for the very first time go up and
get rid of this void which as of today
means this program takes no command line
arguments and I can change it to exactly
this int ARG C string argv with brackets
now it's cryptic admittedly and let me
zoom in but I think we can perhaps infer
now what's going on if main Now does not
have void as its input which means it
takes no arguments surely the spoiler
here is that now main will take command
line argument somehow any guesses as to
what argv is or will be
what might this
represent it's an array of strings right
by way of the syntax
yeah exactly it will be all of the
characters or really all of the words
that you type at the prompt argc as an
INT any
guess
argument count is what it generally
stands for though technically you could
call these things any anything but this
is the convention because I claimed
earlier that arrays don't keep track of
their own length if you want to know how
many words the human typed at the prompt
after your program's name you have to be
told not just the array of the words but
the length of that array the strings you
can figure out the length of using
Sterling but you can't figure out the
length of the array of strings the
collection of words that the human typed
in so how can I now use this well let me
go ahead and do this let me go ahead and
change this program now just to be print
F quote unquote
hello comma uh percent s back sln then
Arvy bracket 1 so this is not the best
version of my code yet but it's my first
make greet and now let me dog greet
David all at once enter hello David now
let me run it again dogre Carter enter
hello Carter you know it's a marginal
Improvement but I don't have to wait for
get string to prompt me to hit enter
it's just speeding things up you know is
fast one less command to type in but I
deliberately did bracket one but where
what's the beginning of arv it would be
bracket zero well what's that this is
sometimes useful though for now it's not
suppose I recompile my code and run this
program now greet David anyone want to
guess what's in argv
Z say
again greet enter hello. SLG greet so if
you want sort of inception style your
program to figure out what its own name
is or at least how it was executed at
the command line at the terminal you can
look at ARG v0 in general probably not
that useful probably better to start
looking at bracket one which was the
first word after the program name and if
there were more I could do this how
about RV bracket 2 let me add in a
second percent s let me recompile greet
let me do greet David maen enter and
that two now works taking in two words
at the prompt if I really want to be
smart at this now I could do something
like this though how about if the count
of arguments AKA AR C equals equals 2
then assume that the human typed in only
their first name and do print F uh hello
comma percent s back sln and then uh
argv bracket 1 else if the human did not
provide exactly two arguments the name
of the program and their own name let's
just print out a default value L they
forgot their name or they typed in two
names or three names let's just do uh
hello comma world as a default and we'll
just ignore what the human typed in if I
recompile this make greet I can dog
greet and David again enter oops uh
sorry what am I missing yeah so newbie
mistake else all right make greet again
dog greet David enter there's my hello
David
but if I omit my name I just get the
generic like a default value and if I
get a little curious and I type in both
names then I get ignored two why because
I just haven't built in support for arxy
of three I could do anything I want but
now we have access to these kinds of
building blocks all right what else
might I do here well it turns out there
might be some final features for us to
now execute um notice though that in C
despite what you might see in books or
online tutorials nowadays the two
official formats for defining a main
function are either this which we've
been using now for Two Plus weeks or now
this whereby you change the void to int
argc and then for now string argv and
then empty brackets and we'll see that
this two is an a simplification some
training wheels if you will but for now
those are the two forms even though you
will see in online tutorials and even
books some people use Maine in different
ways these are the two now to keep in
mind and I'll note that these command
line arguments are kind of all over the
place didn't probably expect to see this
word on the screen here and what does it
mean well it turns out that for decades
there's actually this program that comes
with Linux systems in particular called
coway why probably because someone had
too much free time once and decided to
write a program that creates asy art out
of a cow saying something textually on
the screen but you use coway Just For
Fun by way of command line arguments so
for instance let me propose that uh I go
back to vs code here not because I want
to write any code but I just want to use
my terminal window and let me uh
maximize my terminal window here and let
me go ahead and type in something like
how about c space moo so cow is not a
program I wrote It's been around for
decades but we installed it in vs code
for you in the cloud it takes at least
one command line argument what do you
want the cow to say I can say cow say
moo and hit enter and voila there's my
asky art of a cow saying moo on the
screen it can say multiple words so I
can say hello world and enter and now it
says hello world so this is just an
example of a silly program that uses
command line arguments but it takes
others too just like clang use this
convention of hyphens to change the
output of the program Dash something is
just a super common convention with
commandline arguments when you want a
very tur notation for some option like
output um in C I read the documentation
and it turns out there's a-f command
line argument that allows you to change
the uh the appearance of the cow if you
will so if I do coway dasf duck and then
some other word like quack it's no
longer a cow that command line argument
turns it into a tiny adorable duck
instead and then lastly just for fun
because I spent way too much time
playing with command line arguments uh
c-f dragon and then how about like raar
enter you can even get this on the
screen here so this too is just an
example of what you can do with these
command line arguments now that we have
this building block and there's one
final thing we can now do with code
there's one last feature today that
we'll introduce before we now connect
all of these dots to readability and and
encryption by talking lastly about
something called exit status it turns
out that whenever your main function
exits it returns a secret integer that
you can figure out as the programmer or
an advanced user what it was and these
exit codes exit statuses are typically
used to indicate errors so for instance
over over the past couple of years if
you us zoom and you ever got some kind
of error you might have seen a screen
like this it's usually not that helpful
maybe tells you to click report problem
or contact support but very often in our
human world on Macs PCS and phones you
see cryptic error codes like literally
numbers that probably only Zoom knows or
Microsoft or Google or whatever company
wrote the software you're using but that
number corresponds to a specific error
that some human somewhere knows might
very well happen these are used similar
L although under a different name that
we'll talk about later in the term uh on
the web as well have you ever seen this
maybe not character but number so 404
means
what so error yes but really not found
so why I mean this is the most Arcane
thing and we'll talk in a few weeks
about like what this and other numbers
mean but numbers are all around us in
technology and they very often mean
something to the technical people who
wrote the software less so to humans
like you and me why so many of us
recognize 404 is kind of weird that like
that's been around long enough that we
all know it but it really is just a
special number that represents an error
of some sort so it turns out the last
thing we'll reveal today about what
we've been taking for granted for two
weeks is what the int is in Maine we've
seen just a moment ago that the thing in
the parentheses which up until now has
been void which means no command line
arguments now in Arc string arv brackets
just means yes command line arguments
and we've seen how to access them so the
last piece of the puzzle honestly of all
the cryptic syntax the past two weeks is
just what int means int is always there
for Maine and it indicates that Maine
will always return an integer even
though you and I have never done so
explicitly usually Maine returns Zero by
default but it would be weird if you saw
an error message saying zero so zero is
just hidden you would never see it on
the screen but it's happening
automatically by way of how C is
designed so let me write one final
program here I'll call it for instance
status . C to show you these exit
statuses code of status. c and then up
here let me do something simple like
include
cs50.h then include standard i.h and
then int main uh let's do actually let's
use a command line argument in argc
string argv so that's copy paste but now
let's do this if argc does not equal to
why don't we do something like this
let's not just um default to hello world
like last time let's yell at the user so
let's say something like printf missing
command line argument so that they know
they screwed up and they need to run the
program again correctly else let's go
ahead and say print out uh as before
hello comma percent s and then plug in
argv bracket one so the human's name
from The Prompt now at this point let me
go ahead and run
statusstatus and I'll will type nothing
first first I get yelled at this time
I'll type it again/ status David and it
works properly but now let me show you a
somewhat secret cryptic command you can
type this at your prompt and it's just a
coincidence that there's another dollar
sign Echo dollar sign question mark
totally Arcane but it allows you to see
what exit status your program has ended
with so let me run this again the wrong
way/ status okay I get the error message
what was secretly returned I can't can't
see it there's obviously no error screen
but by typing Echo dollar sign question
mark I can see that oh my program
automatically by default return zero
however if I run it again correctly
status David enter this is the correct
version but if I run Echo question mark
status again it's still entered with
zero and long story short this is just a
missed opportunity when something goes
wrong why don't I return a value other
than zero zero by default means success
and it's always there automatically but
but you can control this I can go into
my code here and return one else if
something works fine I can return zero
by default and honestly if I omit the
return zero again zero automatically is
returned so let me go ahead and though
be explicit just so I know what's going
on make status
again/ status and let's do this
correctly with David enter hello David
Echo question mark uh Echo dollar sign
question mark zero so all is well
but now if I do/ status and nothing or
multiple things but not just David enter
I get the error message but now if I do
Echo dollar sign question mark waa there
now is the one so what does this now
mean this is in the graphical world we
would just show something like this on
the screen which is a little more
informative to the user but even in the
Linux world we don't have a guey
necessarily even for the programs we've
written you can check these exit
statuses and in fact more comfortable
more advanced programmers when they
write code that calls programs be it
coway or anything else you can encode
check what the exit status is of a
program and then decide did my program
work or did it not and now let's connect
the final dots uh before we adjourn for
some fruit snacks uh cryptography namely
one of the applications this week via
which you'll be able to send if you will
secret messages and better yet decre
secret messages this will be in addition
to perhaps analyzing the readability of
text using puristic like we identified
at the start of class 2 so a
cryptography is just the art the science
of encrypting information scrambling
information so that if you have a secret
message to send in so-called plain text
you can run it through some algorithm
and turn it into what's called Cipher
text thereby encrypting it and only
someone who knows what algorithm you've
used and what input you've used to the
algorithm theoretically can decrypt that
process and convert it back to the
original message so if we use our mental
model from last week here is a problem
here is an input and output the goal I
claim here is to take some plain text
like the message you want to send think
back to grade school if you ever passed
a note to a friend or to your crush
saying I love you it's a little awkward
if the teacher or someone else
intercepts the paper and in English it
just says I love you or whatever it is
it'd be nice if you had at least
encrypted it in some way but the other
person needs to know what algorithm you
used and what inputs you used to that
algorithm so that ultimately they can
decode the so-called Cipher text which
is the output so what go inside of the
box today well an algorithm as it
relates to cryptography is called a
cipher and a cipher is a fancy name for
an algorithm that encrypts text from
plain text to Cipher text the catch is
there needs to be not just the algorithm
there needs to be an input to it and so
for instance you might draw the picture
like this for the first time today and
we've seen this in code you can give
multiple inputs or arguments to
functions so in this black box can you
imagine passing in the message you want
to send and then some Secret so for
instance suppose that the simplest thing
I could think of as a kid was instead of
sending the letter A why don't I write
the letter b instead of the letter B why
don't I write the letter c so I can kind
of shift the English alphabet by one
space so a becomes b b becomes C dot dot
dot Z becomes a you can wrap around at
the end and let's assume no punctuation
in this part of the story so that's a
very simple algorithm add a value to
each letter and send the value as the
cipher text and now the teacher the
classmate they have to know that you use
not only this rotational algorithm also
known as a Caesar Cipher they also need
to know what number you use did you add
one to every letter two to every letter
25 to every letter now if they're super
smart and probably not the the young age
in this story they could also just try
all possibilities and that would be an
attack on the algorithm this is not a
sophisticated algorithm but it's enough
to send a message in class so if the two
inputs now are high as the plain text
message and one as the so-called key the
secret number that only you and the
other person know you might uh be able
to encrypt a message from one way to the
other and so in this case for instance
high would become i j exclamation point
in this version of the algorithm we're
not going to bother with numbers or
punctuation will only operate on a
through z be it uppercase or lowercase
so now if you were to receive a a slip
of paper in class with i j on it you
know you the recipient would know what
it is so long as you know that the
sender used one because you just reverse
the algorithm and you subtract one
instead the teacher you know they
probably don't know what this means and
they're not going to spend time hacking
the message so it just looks scrambled
to them and that's what we get from
encryption someone who intercepts it be
it in class or in the real world on the
Internet or anywhere else can't actually
figure out ideally what it is you have
sent the opposite of course is indeed
called decryption but the process is the
same we now pass in negative one and so
how about this why don't we end with a
demonstration here
u y JT xbt
dt50 there's a bit of a tell there if we
pass that in and do Nega -1 well how do
we get out the plain text originally
well if this is the cipher text and we
subtract one from each letter I think U
becomes t i becomes h j becomes i t
becomes s x becomes w b becomes a t
becomes s d becomes c t becomes s and
this was indeed cs50 have a duck on your
way out and some snacks in the
[Applause]
[Music]
lobby
oh
[Music]
all right all right this is cs50 and
this is week three already wherein we'll
take a look back actually at week zero
where we first began and in week zero
recall that everything was very
intuitive in a sense we talked not just
about representation of information but
algorithms and we talked about tearing a
phone book again and again and that
somehow got us to a better solution but
today we'll try to start formalizing
some of those ideas and capturing some
of those same ideas not in pseudo code
just yet but in uh actual code as well
but we'll also consider the the
efficiency of those algorithms like just
how good how welld designed our
algorithms actually are and if you
recall when we did the phone book
example where in I first had an
algorithm searching one page at a time
and then second when two pages at a time
and then third started tearing the thing
in half recall that we with a wave of
the hand kind of analyzed it as follows
we proposed that if the x-axis here is
the size of the problem like number of
pages in a phone book and the y- axis is
the time required to solve the problem
in seconds minutes page tears whatever
your unit of measuring is recall that
the first algorithm was this straight
line such that if you had n pages in the
phone book it might have this slope of N
and there's this one toone relationship
between pages and tears two pages at a
time of course was twice as fast but
still really the same shape the yellow
line here indicating that yeah it's n /
two maybe plus one if you have to double
back as we discussed but it's really
still fundamentally the same algorithm
one or two pages at a time but the third
algorithm recall was this one here in
green where we called it logarithmic in
terms of how fast or how slow it was and
indeed the implication of this algorithm
was that we could even double the size
of the phone book and no big deal one
additional page tear and we take yet
another thousand page bite out of the
phone book so today we'll revisit some
of these ideas formalize them a bit but
also translate some of them ultimately
to code and all of that now is possible
because we have this lower level
understanding perhaps of like what's
actually inside of your computer this of
course is your computer's Ram or memory
and recall that if we kind of start to
abstract this away your compter
computer's memory is really just a grid
of bites in fact we don't have to look
at the hardware anymore and we looked at
a grid of bites like this whereby each
of these bites could be used to store a
Char an INT a long or even an entire
string at that but let's focus perhaps
just on a subset of this because last
week of course we emphasized really
arrays storing things in arrays and that
allowed us to start storing entire
strings sequences of characters and even
arrays of integers if we want to have
multiple ones and not just multiple
variables as well but the catch is that
if you look inside of an array in the
computer's memory and for instance
suppose these integers here are stored
it's pretty easy for us humans to glance
at this and immediately find the number
50 you sort of have this bird's eye view
from where you're seated of everything
on the screen and so it's pretty obvious
how you get to the number 50 but in the
world of computers of course it turns
out that this is hardware and computers
for today's purposes can only do one
thing at a time they can't just take it
all in and find instantly some number
like 50 so perhaps a decent metaphor is
to consider the array of memory inside
of your computer really is a sequence of
of closed doors and if the computer
wants to find some value in an array it
has to do the digital equivalent of
opening each of these doors one at a
time now how can code do that well of
course we introduced indices or indexes
last week whereby we by convention call
the first element of an array location
zero the second location one the Third
location two and so forth so-called zero
indexed and this allowed us to now
bridge this conceptual world of like
what's going on in memory with actual
code because now we had this square
bracket syntax via which we could go
searching for something if we so choose
and it turns out if I now uh paint these
red instead of yellow it would seem that
we actually have a pretty good physical
metaphor here standing in place for what
would be a computer's uh array of memory
if for instance you're storing some
seven numbers like that and so today we
begin with a look of a specific type typ
of algorithm that is for searching like
searching is all over the place all of
us have probably gone to google.com or
some equivalent like already multiple
times per day and getting back answers
fast is what companies like Google are
really good at so how are they doing
that how are they storing information in
computers uh memory well let's consider
what this really is it's really just a
problem as it was back in week zero the
input though to the problem for now
might be this array of seven lockers so
that's the input to the problem inside
of which is a number and maybe for
Simplicity now we just want a yes no a
true false answer a bull that is to say
of whether or not some number like 50 is
in that array it's not quite as fancy as
Google that doesn't just tell you yes we
have search results it actually gives
you the search results but for now we'll
keep it simple and just output as part
of this problem yes or no true or false
we have found the number we're looking
for given an input like that array but
it turns out inside of this black box
that we keep coming back to there's all
sorts of possible algorithms and we talk
about this at a high level conceptually
in week zero with the phone book but
today let's consider it a little more
concretely uh by way of a game that some
of you might have grown up with namely
Monopoly and so behind these doors it
turns out we'll be hidden some
denominations of Monopoly money but for
this we now have two volunteers if you'd
like to greet the world hi I'm
Jackson yay hi my name is Stephanie
Steph and you want to say a little
something about yourselves years house
first year living in Matthews
nice and I'm a first year in Canada nice
well Welcome to our two
volunteers so why don't we do this would
one of you like to volunteer the other
to go
first all go first okay all right so
Stephanie's up first and behind one of
these doors here we've hidden the
Monopoly money 50 and so we'd like you
to find the 50 we'll tell you nothing
more about the lockers but we would like
you to execute a certain algorithm and
in fact I'm going to give you some
pseudo code for this and I'm going to
give you the name for it it's called
linear search and as the name implies
you're pretty much going to end up
walking in sort of a straight line but
how are you going to do this well let me
propose that in a moment your first step
will be to think kind of like a loop for
each door from left to right what do we
want you to do on each iteration well if
50 is behind that door then we want to
go ahead and have you return true and
sort of hold up the 50 proudly if you
will for the group otherwise if you get
through that whole Loop and you haven't
found the number 50 you can just throw
up your hands and disappointment false
you've not found the number 50 so to be
clear step one is going to be for each
uh door from left to right how would you
like to
begin yep oh and then yep there we go
yep oh and if you'd like to at least
tell oh good good acting here what have
you found instead it's not 50 but 20 oh
okay so step one was a fail so let's
move on to step two inside of the Loop
what are you going to do next I'm going
to move to the next door
okay almost okay almost sort of a 500
instead next Locker I would rather
take
no okay we're not telling the
audience oh okay so keep going this is
step three
now
oh
[Music]
man five okay few more lockers to
check a little sad
guys all right second to last
step this one kind of close all right
and finally the last clearly you've been
perhaps set up here let's go all right
so the number
50 and Stephanie if I may let me ask you
a question here so on the screen this is
the pseudo code you just executed
suppose though I had done what many of
us have gotten into the habit of doing
when you have a if condition you often
have an else Branch as well suppose that
I had done this now and I'm marking it
in red to be clear this is wrong but
what would have have been bad about this
code using an if and an else might you
say any
instincts
um then you would end up like cancelling
canceling the code before you found the
50 yeah exactly just be eternally sad
indeed when Stephanie had opened the
first Locker she had found 20 20 of
course is not 50 she would have decreed
false but of course she hadn't checked
all of the rest of the locker so that
would seem to be a key detail that would
this implementation of the SoDo coat we
actually do go through as we did and
only return false not even with an else
but just at the end of the loop such
that we only reach that line if we don't
return truer uh earlier than that well
let's go ahead and do this let me take
the mic from you if you'd like to take a
seat next to Jackson Jackson in just a
moment we'll have you come up Carter if
you don't mind reorganizing the uh
lockers for us but in the meantime let
me point out how we might now translate
that same idea to code pretty high level
pretty English oriented with that pseudo
code but really now as of last week we
have syntax via which Stephanie and soon
Jackson could treat this Locker the set
of lockers as really indeed an array
using bracket notation so we can now get
a little closer in our pseudo code to
actual code and the way a computer
scientist for instance would translate
fairly high level English pseudo code
like this to something that's a little
closer to C or any language that
supports arrays would be a little more
cryptically like this but you'll see
more of this syntax in the coming days
for I from 0 to n minus one this is
still pseudo code but that's kind of
like the english-like way of expressing
what we've known come to know as a for
Loop if 50 is behind doors bracket I so
I'm assuming for the sake of discussion
that doors now is the name of my
variable this array of seven doors but
then the rest of the logic the rest of
the pseudo code really is the same way
and so you'll find in time that
programmers computer scientists more
generally when you start expressing
ideas algorithms to someone else instead
of maybe operating at this level here
you now have in your vocabulary really a
new new syntax that you can be a little
more specific not getting so into the
weeds of writing actual C code but at
least now doing something that's a
little closer to manipulating an array
like this so Jackson would you like to
uh stand on up all right yes yes support
for Jackson here too
nice and here now I'm going to allow you
an assumption that Stephanie did not
have Stephanie clearly was really doing
her best searching from left to right
using linear searches we'll Now call it
but they were pretty much in random
order right there was a 20 over there
there was a one over there and then a 50
so we deliberately jumbled things up and
did not sort the numbers for her but
Carter kindly has just come up to give
you a leg up Jackson by sorting the
numbers in advance and we'd like you
this time much like in week zero to do
something again and again but this time
using what we'll Now call binary search
it's exactly the same algorithm
conceptually as we did in week zero but
if we translate to the context of this
array we might now might say something
like this the first step for Jackson
might be to ask ask the question if 50
is behind the middle door where
presumably he's done some mental math to
figure out what the middle is then he's
going to just return true and hopefully
we'll get lucky and 50 will be right
there of course there's two other
possibilities at least which would be
what 50 is with respect to these
doors yeah so to the left or to the
right alternatively so if 50 is less
than the middle door then presumably
Jackson's going to want to go left else
if 50 is greater than the middle door
he's going to want to go right much like
I did uh physically last week with the
phone book dividing and conquering left
to right but there's actually a a fourth
case let's put it on the board first
what else might happen here that Jackson
should
consider yeah oh it's not there it's not
there so let me actually go back and
amend my my pseudo code here and just
say Jackson if we don't hand you any
doors at all or eventually as he's
dividing and conquering if he's left
with no more doors we have to handle
that situation so that the def behavior
is defined find all right so with that
said Jackson do you want to go ahead and
find us the number 50 and walk us
through verbally what you're doing and
finding all right so it looks like this
one is the middle door so I'm going to
open
it but it's 20 not 50 oh sad okay what's
going through your head now so now I'm
looking because 50 is higher than 20 I
want to look to the right good um and
look for the new middle door which would
be here nice and it's 100 sad um but 50
is less than 100 so now we know to look
left which would be here and Tada nice
very well done this time around
too
so thank you first to our volunteers
here and in fact um since you're fan of
Monopoly as we're so informed we have
the Cambridge edition of Monopoly with
all your Harvard favorites here you go
thank you so thank you to our volunteers
for finding us 50
so kind of was more popular than we
expected so here we can translate this
one more time into something a little
closer to code and again still pseudo
code but here now might be another
formulation of exactly what Jackson just
did just using the nomenclature now of
arrays where you can be a little more
precise with your instructions and still
leave it to someone else to translate
this finally to code but here we have
same question at the beginning if no
doors left return false if 50 is behind
doors bracket middle so I'm assuming
here because this is pseudo code that
somewhere I've done the mental math or
the actual math to figure out what the
index of middle is for instance if these
are seven doors in an array this would
be location zero 1 2 3 4 5 6 so somehow
I've taken the total number of doors
seven divided by two to find the middle
that's three and a half we have to deal
with rounding but suffice it to say
there's a well- defined formula for
finding the middle index given the total
number of lockers divide by two and then
round accordingly so that's presumably
what Jackson did just by counting in his
head to find us door number three not
the third door the fourth door but door
bracket three so this is just saying if
50 is behind door is bracket middle
return true that was not the case he
found a $20 bill instead else if 50 is
less than the uh doors bracket middle go
ahead and now it gets interesting search
doors zero through doors middle minus
one so it's getting a little more to the
Weeds now but if middle is three this
one here well we want to now have
Jackson search if 50 had been uh if the
number had been less we want to start at
bracket zero and go up through this one
when we deliberately subtract one CU
what's the point of looking in the same
Locker again we might as well do zero
through middle minus one else if 50 is
greater than doors bracket middle which
it was what did we then do Jackson
intuitively searched for doors middle
plus one through door
n minus one and honestly it gets a
little Annoying having the pluses and
the minuses here but just think of what
it means this is the middle door and
Jackson then did proceed to search
through doors middle plus one because
there's no point in searching this one
again and then the last element in any
array of size n where n is just our
go-to number uh for the size is always
going to be n minus one it's not going
to be n it's going to be n minus one
because we always start counting at Rays
at zero so here then we have a
translation into pseudo code that's a
little closer to C of this exact same
idea and here we come full circle to
week zero like in week zero is pretty
intuitive to imagine dividing and
conquering a problem like this but if
you now think back to actual your iPhone
your Android phone or the like when
you're doing autocomplete and searching
the list it's possible if you don't have
many friends or family or colleagues in
the phone you know what linear search
just checking every name for the person
you're searching for might be perfectly
fine but odds are your phones being
smarter than that especially if you
start to have dozens hundreds thousands
of people in your contacts over the
years what would be better than linear
search well perhaps binary search but
but but there's an assumption a
requirement which is what why was
Jackson ultimately able to find the 50
in just like three steps instead of a
full seven like
Stephanie because the array was sorted
and so this is sort of a teaser for what
we'll have to come back to later today
well you know how much effort did it
take someone like Carter how much effort
does it take your phone to sort all of
those names and numbers in advance
because maybe it's not actually worth
the amount of time now someone like
Google probably somehow keeps the
database of web pages sorted you could
imagine it being super slow if when you
type in cats or something else into
google.com if they searched linearly
over their entire data set ideally
they're doing something a little smarter
than that so we'll formalize now exactly
this kind of analysis and it's not going
to be so much mathy as it still will be
in intuitive but we'll introduce you to
some some jargon some terminology that
most any programmer or computer
scientist might use when analyzing their
own algorithms let's formalize now what
this kind of analysis is so right right
now I claim binary search better than
linear search but how much better and
why exactly well it all comes back to
this kind of graph so this recall is how
we analyzed the phone book back in week
zero and recall that indeed we had these
these formulas rough formulas that
describe the running time of those three
algorithms one page at a time two pages
at a time and then tearing the thing
again and again in half and precisely if
you count it up the number of pages I
was touching or the number of pages I
was tearing it's fair to say that the
first algorithm in the worst case might
have taken n total Pages it didn't
because I was searching for John Harvard
at the time which is somewhat early in
the alphabet but if I were searching
with some for someone with the last name
of Z I would have had to keep going and
going in the worst case through all n
Pages not as bad for the second
algorithm and that's why we do n divided
by two and even that's a bit of a white
lie right it's probably n / 2 + 1 in
case I have to double back but again I'm
sort of doing this more generally to
capture the essence of these things and
then we really got into the weeds with
like log base 2 of n for that third and
final algorithm and at the time we
claimed anytime you're doing dividing
something in half in half in half odds
are there's going to be some kind of
logarithm involved and we'll see that
today but today we're going to actually
start using computer science terminology
and we're going to sort of formalize
this imprecision if you will we are not
going to care generally about exactly
how many steps some algorithm takes
because that's not going to be that
enlightening especially if maybe you
have a faster computer tomorrow than you
did today it wouldn't really be fair to
compare numbers too precisely we really
kind of want to with a wave of the hand
just get a sense of roughly how slow or
how fast an algorithm is so the notation
here is deliberate that is literally a
capital O often italicized referred to
as Big O and so the first algorithm is
in Big O of n the second algorithm is in
Big O of n / two the third algorithm is
in Big O of log base 2 of n but even
that is kind of unnecessary detail when
using Big O notation you really don't
care about we'll see the smaller ordered
terms right we're not going to care
about the divided by two because you
know what the shape of these algorithms
is almost the same and really the idea
the algorithm itself is sort of
fundamentally the same okay and instead
of one page at a time I'm doing two but
if you throw millions of pages billions
of pages at me those algorithms are
really going to kind of perform the same
as n gets really large goes off toward
infinity and the same is true for
logarithms even if you're a little rusty
it turns out that whether you do the
math with log base 2 log base 3 log base
10 you can just multiply one by the
other to really get the same formula
this is only to say a computer scientist
would generally say that the first two
algorithms are on the order of eps the
third algorithm is on the order of log
end steps and we don't really care
precisely what we mean beyond that and
this Big O notation as we'll see and
actually let me let me zoom out if you
can imagine suddenly making the x- axis
much longer so more pages on the screen
at once it is indeed going to be the
shapes of these curves that matter
because imagine in your mind's eye as
you zoom out zoom out zoom out zoom out
and as n gets much much much bigger on
the xaxis the red and the yellow line
are essentially going to look the same
once n is sufficiently large but the
green line is never going to look the
same it's going to be a fundamentally
different shape and so that's the
intuition of bigo to get a sense of
these uh rates of performance like this
so here then is Big O here is perhaps a
cheat sheet of like the common formulas
that a computer scientist certainly in
an introductory context might use when
analyzing algorithms and let's consider
for a moment which of our first two
algorithms linear search and binary
search fall into these categories so
I've ordered them from sort of slowest
to fastest so order of n s it's not
something we've actually seen yet but it
tends to be slow because it's quadratic
you're doing n * n that's got to add up
to a lot of steps better today is going
to be n Lin even better is going to be n
even better than that is login and best
is soall order of one like one step or
maybe two steps maybe even a thousand
steps but a fixed finite number of steps
that never changes no how matter how big
n is so given this chart just to be
clear linear search let's consider the
worst case in the worst case how many
steps did it take someone like Stephanie
to find the uh solution to the problem
assuming not seven doors but n doors
yeah so on the order of N and in this
case it's exactly n but you know what
you know maybe it's arguably too n right
because it took Stephanie a couple of
steps like she had to lift the latch she
had to open the door maybe it's three
steps you had to show the money so now
it's 3n 2 N but there we don't really
care about that level of precision we
really just care about the fundamental
number of operations so we'll say yes on
the order of n so that might be an upper
bound we'll call this for linear search
and how about binary search in Jackson's
case or in general me and week zero if
there's end doors how many steps did it
take Jackson or me using binary
search in this case it was literally
three but that's not a
formula yeah so it's on the order of log
n and indeed if there's seven doors well
that's almost eight if you just do a
little bit of rounding and indeed if you
take log base 2 of eight okay so that
does actually give us three so the math
actually checks out and if you're not
comy with logarithms no big deal just
think about it intuitively uh logarithm
of base two is just dividing something
again and again so on this chart when we
consider Big O which to be clear allows
you to describe the order of an
algorithm's running time like the
magnitude of it but it also describes
more specifically an upper bound so in
the worst case for instance these are
pretty good measures of how good uh or
rather of how bad linear search and
binary search might be why well suppose
you're searching a thousand page phone
book and the person's name starts with z
the algorithm is still going to be on
the order of n steps why because it
might take you as many as all end steps
to find it now that's not necessarily
going to be the case in practice if I
use Big O as an upper bound well it
would be nice if there's sort of a
corresponding lower bound especially if
you want to consider not just best uh
worst cases but maybe best cases so what
might we use here well so this is a
capital Greek omega symbol so Omega is
the symbol that a computer scientist
uses generally to describe a lower bound
on an algorithm often in the context of
best case though not necessarily so a
lower bound means how few steps might an
algorithm take and here too same
formulas and we'll fill in these blanks
over time some algorithms might always
take a minimum of n squ steps or on the
order of n steps some might only take n
logn or n or log n or one so something
like uh linear search when Stephanie
started with linear search she didn't
get lucky this time on stage but what if
she had and the first door she opened
were 50 how much you then describe the
lower bound on linear search in this
so-called best
case using this list of possible
answers yeah yeah so Omega of one so in
the best case the lower bound on how
many steps it might take uh linear
search to find something might just be
one step why because maybe Stephanie had
gotten lucky and we had pre-filled these
lockers with the numbers in some other
order such that she might have open the
first locker and waila the number 50
could have been there so a lower bound
arguably could indeed be Omega of one
for linear search and how about now for
Jackson he used binary search so he
dived right into the middle of the
problem but what would be a lower bound
on binary search using this logic yeah
yeah so again Omega of one why because
maybe he just gets lucky and indeed
right in the middle of the lockers could
have been the number 50 it wasn't and so
more Germain in Jackson's uh actual
practice would have been the Big O
discussion but Big O and Omega upper
bound and lower bound just allow a
computer scientist to kind of wrestle
with what could happen maybe in the
worst case what can happen in the best
case and you can even get even more
precise like the average case or the
like and this is indeed what Engineers
might do at a whiteboard in a company in
a university when designing an algorithm
and trying to make arguments as to like
why their algorithm is better than
someone else's by way of these kinds of
analyses and just so you've seen it it
turns out that if some algorithm happens
to have an identical upper bound and
lower bound you can actually use a
capital Greek Theta as well and this is
the last of the the Greek symbols today
but a Greek Theta indicates a coinci
idents of both upper bound and lower
bound that is they are one and the same
that was not the case for our discussion
a second ago of linear search not the
case for binary search but you could use
the same kinds of formulas if it turns
out that your upper bound and lower
bound are the same so for instance if I
were to count everyone like literally in
this room 1 2 3 4 five six and so forth
you could actually say that counting in
that way is in Theta of n right because
I in the best case it's going to take me
end points at the uh people in the
audience in the worst case it's going to
take me n it's always going to take me
end steps if I want to count everyone in
the room you can't really do better than
that unless you skip people so that
would be an example off the cuff of
something where Theta is instead germine
are any questions now on Big O on Omega
or Theta which are now just more formal
tools in the toolkit for talking about
the design of our
algorithms any
questions
no seeing none yeah oh is this yes no
okay so we're good so let's go ahead and
translate this perhaps to some some
actual code let me go over to vs code
here and let's see if we can't now
translate some of these ideas to some
actual code not so much using new syntax
yet we're going to still operate in this
world of arrays like last week so let me
go ahead and create a program called
search. C by executing code space
search. c in my terminal and then up
here let's go ahead and include our
usual so include cs50.h so I can get
some input include standard i.h so I can
print some output we'll do int main void
which the meaning of which we did start
to tease apart last week the fact that
it's void again today just means no
command line arguments and let me go
ahead and do this let me go ahead and
declare just for discussion's sake a
static array like an array that never
changes and the Syntax for this is going
to be give me an array called numbers
using the square bracket not ation and
I'm going to immediately initialize it
to 20 500 10 5 100 1 and 50 reminiscent
of those same denominations as before so
this is a slightly new syntax that we've
uh perhaps not seen and the curly braces
here which are different from for loops
and while loops and functions just tell
the compiler please give me an array of
whatever size this is containing those
numbers left to right I could
alternatively use last week's syntax of
saying something like this let's see one
2 3 4 5 six seven denominations I could
alternatively do this and then I could
say numbers bracket 0 uh numbers bracket
0 equals 20 numbers bracket 1 equal 500
and I could do this five more times
that's just a little tedious if you know
the numbers in advance you don't have to
tell the compiler how many there are you
can just let it figure it out that your
numbers are be will be 20 500 10 5 100 1
and 5050 so this is how you statically
Define an array all right let me just go
ahead and ask the user now for a number
we'll call it n by using get int and
prompting them for a number so nothing
new there and now let me go ahead and
Implement linear search and the pseudo
code we had for this before used some
array like notation let me go ahead then
and start similarly four in I and it's
you almost always start counting at I by
convention so that's perhaps a good
starting point I'm going to do this so
long as I is less than seven not the
best design to hard code the seven but
this is just for demonstration sake for
now because I know how many numbers I
put in there and then I'm going to do
i++ so now I have the beginnings of a
loop that will just allow me to iterate
over the entire array and let me ask
this if the current number at location I
equals equals n which is the number the
human typed in then let's go ahead and
do something simple like print F quote
unquote found back sln and then per our
discussion last week to indicate that
this is successful I'm going to going to
return zero if I found it and if I don't
find it I'm just going to go down here
and by default say not found back sln
and just for convention whoops just for
good measure per convention I'll return
one or really any value other than zero
zero recall means success and any other
integer tends to mean error of some sort
irrespective of the number I'm looking
for so just to revisit the only thing
that's new here is the syntax for
creating an array of seven numbers these
numbers and then after after that we
have really highlighted here an
implementation of linear search I mean
this is the C version I dare say of what
Stephanie did on the board whereas now
the array is called numbers instead of
doors but I think it's pretty much the
same let me go ahead and open my
terminal window and run make
search seems to compile okay search and
let's go ahead and search for a number
we'll start with what we did before 50
and it's found let's go ahead and run it
again/ search let's search for maybe 20
at the beginning that one too is found
let's run it one more time searching for
like 1,000 which is not uh in among the
uh denominations and that one indeed is
not found so we've taken an idea from
week zero now formalized in week three
and just translated it now to code
questions on this implementation of
linear
search linear
search nothing oh so successful so far
today okay so let's see if we can't
maybe make this a little more
interesting and see if we can't trip
over a detail that's going to be
important in C instead of doing numbers
let me go ahead and do this we'll stay
on theme with Monopoly and I went down
the rabbit hole of reading the
wikkipedia article on Monopoly and the
original uh pieces or tokens that came
with Monopoly and it turns out we can
represent those with strings so I'm
going to create an array called strings
plural of whatever size I defined here
and the very first first Monopoly pieces
back in the day were a battleship that
you could play with a boot a cannon an
iron a
thimble and a top hat some of which you
might know from the game nowadays turns
out they've been changing these uh had
no idea over the years so here is now an
array of strings let me go ahead and
prompt the user now not for an integer
anymore I want to Now search for one of
these strings still using linear search
so let me create a string s set it equal
to string prompt the user for a string
to search for and then I think my code
here is almost the same except for one
detail I now have an array called
strings I now have a variable called s
but it turns out for reasons we'll
explore in more detail next week this
line of code is not going to work and it
turns out the reason has to do with what
we discussed last week of like what a
string really is and what is a string
again a string is an array and it turns
out though that equals equals is not
going to generously compare all of the
characters in an array for you just
because you use equal equals it turns
out it's not going to compare every
letter and so thankfully there is in the
uh string library that we introduced
last week a solution to this problem the
reason for the problem we'll explore in
more detail next week but for now just
know that when you want to compare
strings in C especially if you've come
into the class knowing a bit of Java or
python or some other language you cannot
use equals equals even though you could
in scratch you cannot in C so what I
have to actually do here is this I have
to ask the question does the return
value of a function called stir compare
or stir
comp equal zero when passed in the
current string and that user input so if
you read the documentation for this
function called stir compare you'll see
that it takes two strings as input first
one and second one it then someone
decades ago wrote the code that probably
uses a four Loop or a while loop to
compare every character in each of those
strings and it turns out it returns zero
if they are in fact equal turns out too
it will return a positive number or a
negative number in other situations any
intuition for why it might actually be
useful to have a function that allows
you to check if two strings are equal
if they're not equal what else might be
interesting to know when comparing two
strings are if certain values
are okay possibly maybe you want to know
just how similar they are um and that's
indeed an algorithm unto itself but stir
compare is a little simpler than
that exactly if you're trying to like
alphabetize a whole list of strings just
like your phone probably is for your
context or address book it turns out
that stir compare will actually return a
positive number or a negative number or
a zero based on whether maybe it comes
alphabetically first or later or or in
fact equal so that can be a useful thing
and that's just a teaser for a lower
level explanation that we'll see next
week so now let me cross my fingers and
see if I got this right let me go ahead
and do make
search did compile okay albeit slowly
do/ search and let's search for
something like the thimble and we see
that that's indeed found otherwise let's
search for something that I know isn't
there like a race car which was there
when I grew up but huh segmentation
fault core dumped like and actually some
of you have tripped over this error
before anyone want to admit seeing this
so yeah not something we've talked about
and um honestly not something I intended
just now but that too we'll see next
week any intuition for why my program
just
broke I didn't really change the logic
it's still linear search let me hide the
terminal so you can see all of the code
at once the only thing I did was
switched from integers to Strings and I
switched to stir compare here but
segmentation fault happened and the
teaser is that that somehow relates to
the computer's memory
yeah yeah and this is subtle but spot on
so 1 2 3 4 5 six elements total in this
array versus the seven number
of Monopoly denominations that we had
earlier and this is where see sort of
case in point this came back to bite me
the fact that I hardcoded this value as
to opposed to maybe separating it out as
a constant or declaring it higher up
kind of bit me here because now I'm
iterating over an array of size six but
clearly I'm going one step too far
because I'm literally going to iterate
seven times not six so it's as though
I'm looking at memory that's over here
and indeed next week we'll focus on
memory and that's just a bad thing so
odds are not even and seeing your code
from this past week if any of you have
had segmentation faults odds are you
touched memory that you shouldn't have
you maybe looped too many times you
might have uh used a negative number to
get into your array in general you
touched memory that you shouldn't have
and you touched a segment of memory that
you shouldn't have the fix though at
least in my case is simple just don't do
that so let me go ahead and recompile
this make uh
search do/ search and I'll search again
for uh race car and
and now it does not crash but it does
tell me it's not found so subtle but
something you might yourself have
tripped over already questions then on
what I just did intentionally or
otherwise yeah in
front return don't return Z return so
what
the a really good question so the
program will still work even if I don't
return zero or return one in fact let me
go ahead head and do that and just hide
my terminal window for a second let's
get rid of the return here let's get rid
of the return here however Watch What
Happens here uh let me go ahead and
recompile this make search Let Me scroll
up in my code here let me go ahead and
do do/ search and let me go ahead and
search for the first thing in the list
Battleship so I know that this should be
found I hit
enter huh interesting so it's saying
found not found but do you see why
logically in this case
exactly so the loop is still running so
there's a couple of solutions to this I
could for instance somehow break out of
the code here but that's going to still
result in line 18 executing I could then
instead just return here I don't
strictly need to return one down at the
bottom but I made this claim last week
that it tends to be helpful as your
programs get more sophisticated to at
least signify just like a real world
programmer error codes when something
goes wrong so returning zero in main is
the easiest way to signify my code is
done I'm ready to exit successfully
that's it but down here I could
absolutely still return zero because
it's not a huge deal it's not really an
error that deserves annoying the user
with some kind of popup that something
went wrong but return one is just a
lower level way of signaling H it didn't
really find what I was looking for and
remember from last week you can see this
as follows if I recompile this again now
that I've reverted those changes so make
search and if I do uh /search and search
for Battleship which is indeed found
recall I can execute this magical
command Echo dollar sign question mark
which you're not going to often execute
but it shows you what main returned if I
run search again and search for race car
which is not found I see not found but I
can also run this command again and see
that oh it returned one so now if you
fast forward a few months a few years
when you're actually writing code in a
company or for larger projects you might
want to be automating software you might
not want the human to necessarily be
running it manually you might want um
code to be automated by some nightly
process or something like that using
these exit codes can a program determine
yes or no that other code succeeded or
failed other questions on linear search
in this
way no all right well let's translate
this to one other feature of uh C here
by incorporating these ideas now into
one other program so I'm going to create
a phone book in C by doing code space
phone
book.car a phone book for an actual name
and getting back a number so I'm going
to go ahead and quickly include some of
the same things cs50.h so we can get
input uh standard io. so we can print
output and I'm going to preemptively
include string.h in case we need that
one as well uh int main void no need for
uh command line arguments today and let
me me give myself now an array of names
for this phone book so string names
equals and then in curly braces how
about Carter will be one person in the
phone book and David myself will be the
other so we'll keep it short so we don't
have to type too many names but this is
a phone book with two people thus far
suppose now we want to also store
Carter's phone number in mind so it's
not just saying found or not found it's
literally looking up our phone numbers
like a proper phone book well at the
moment there's really no way to do this
I could do something hackish like I
could put a number like
617495 1000 after Carter I could maybe
do something like 949 uh 468 2750 after
me but now you're kind of doing the
whole apples and oranges thing right
like now it's not strings it's a string
int string int all right so maybe I
could just make all of these strings but
now it's just a conceptual mixing of
apples and oranges like yes that's an
array of four strings but now you're on
the honor System to know that the first
string is a name the second string is a
number the third string is like you can
do it but it's a bit of a hack so to
speak so what might be cleaner than this
instead of combining our phone numbers
into the same array as our names what
else might we do that's perhaps a little
better say a little
Lou a 2d array uh possibly something we
could do I'm going to keep it even
simpler now because we haven't used
those by name even though that is we saw
last week technically what argv is what
else could I do if I want to store names
and numbers
yeahp yeah let me go with this
suggestion just it's a little simpler
rather than complicate things in
literally different dimensions let me go
ahead and do string well I could do int
numbers but you know what so that we can
support punctuation like dashes or even
parentheses or country codes I'm going
to do this instead I'm going to do
string numbers so that I can represent
Carter's number as quote unquote plus
one for the US 617 495 1,000 complete
with hyphens as is us convention and
then for mine I'll go ahead and do + one
949 how about 468
275 semi colon and now down below let's
actually enable the user to search this
phone book just like in week zero we did
string name equals get string and let's
ask the user for a name presumably David
or Carter or someone else and now let's
re-implement linear search so four in I
gets zero I is less than two and do as I
say not as I do I think we should beware
this coding but we'll keep it simple for
now i++ and then in this for loop I
think we have all of the ingredients to
solve this so if the return value of
stir compare of all of the names bracket
I comparing against the name that the
human typed in if all of that equals
equals zero that is all of the
characters in those two strings are
equal then I think we can go ahead and
say found just like last time but you
know what let's actually print Carter or
my phone number so found percent s and
we'll plug in numbers bracket I and then
just for consistency I'll return zero
here and down here how about I'll say
something like uh print F not found just
to be clear and then I'll return one as
well so just a recap here's all of the
code it's almost the same as before
except now it's useful I'm not just
saying found or not found I found a
number in Monopoly or I found a a piece
in Monopoly I'm looking up in one array
of the strings and then I'm printing
from the other array the answer so let
me go ahead here and run the compiler
make phone book enter okay that's
promising no errors do/ phonebook now
and let's search for for instance Carter
enter all right so we found Carter's
number all right let me do that again
phone book Let's search for David all
right we seem to have found David's
number all right let's do it one last
time phone book enter and now we'll
search for like John Harvard enter not
found
all right so I dare say albeit with
minimal testing this code is
correct would anyone now like to
critique the design does something rub
you the wrong way perhaps about this
approach
here and as always think about how if
the program maybe gets longer more
complicated how decisions like this
might unfold
yeah okay so if I is less than two so
technically I if I change the number of
people in this phone book I'm going to
have to update I and we've already seen
that I get myself into trouble so that's
bad design
goodes yeah so again I'm sort of
trusting myself not to screw up if I add
John or anyone else to the first array
but I forget to add their number to the
second array you know eventually things
are going to drift and be inconsistent
and then the just code will be incorrect
at that point so so sort of a poor
design setting me up for future failure
if you will other thoughts
yeah yeah really good we're assuming the
same order from left to right the names
go and from left to right the numbers go
but that's kind of just the honor System
like there's literally nothing in code
preventing me from reversing the order
for whatever reason or maybe sorting the
names like they're sorted now and maybe
that's deliberate but maybe it's not so
this honor System here too is just not
good right I could put a comment in here
to remind myself to uh you know note to
self always update arrays the same way
but like that's something's going to
happen eventually especially when we
have not two but three but 30 300 names
and numbers it would be nice to keep all
of the related data together and so in
fact the one new feature of C we'll
introduce today is one that actually
allows us to implement our very own data
structures you can think of a raay as a
very lightweight data structure and that
allows you to Cluster related data back
to back to back to back and this is how
strings are implemented they are a data
structure effectively implemented with
an array but with c and with other
languages it turns out you can invent
your own data types whether they're one
dimensional two-dimensional even or
Beyond and with uh with C can you
specifically create your own types that
have their own name so for instance
wouldn't it have been nice if C came
with not just Char and int and float and
uh uh long and and others wouldn't it be
nice if C came with a data type called
person and ideally a person would have a
name and a number now that's a little
naive and unrealistic like why would
they define a person to have just those
two Fields certainly people could have
disagreed what a person is so they leave
it to us like the authors of C gave us
all of these Primitives inss and floats
and strings and so forth but it's up to
us now to use those in a more
interesting way so that we can create an
array of person variables if you will
inside of an array called people just to
pluralize it here so how are we going to
do this well for now let's just
stipulate that a person in the world
will have a name and a number that we
could argue all day long what else a
person should have and that's fine you
can invent your own person
eventually at the moment I'm using just
two variables to define a person's name
and number but wouldn't it be nice to
encapsulate that is combined these two
data types into a new and improved data
type called person and the Syntax for
that is going to be this so it's a bit
of a mouthful but you can perhaps infer
what some of this is doing here so it
turns out C has a keyword called type
def as the name kind of suggests this
allows you to Define your own type
struct is an indication that it's a
structure it's like a a structure that
has multiple values inside of it that
you are trying to Define and then at the
very bottom here outside of the Curve
early braces is the name of the type
that you want to create so you don't
have discretion over using type def or
struct in this particular case but you
can name the thing whatever you want and
you can put anything in the structure
that you want as well and as soon as
this semicolon is executed at the bottom
of the code every line thereafter can
now have access to a person data type
whether as a single variable or as an
entire array so if I want to build on
this then let me go ahead and do this
let me go back to my C code here and I'm
going to go ahead and uh change just a
couple of things let's go ahead and do
this I'm going to go ahead and first get
rid of those two hardcoded arrays and
let me go ahead and at the top of my
file invent this type so type def struct
inside of it will be a string name and
then a string number and then the name
of this structure will be person and
best practice would have me Define at
the very top of my file so that any of
my functions in fact could use it even
though I just have Main in this case now
if I want it I could do this like person
P1 and person P2 but we know from last
week like that already is bad design if
you want to have multiple instances of
the same type of variable we should
probably use what
instead and yeah an array so let me not
even go down that road let me instead
just do this person uh will be the type
of the array but I'm going to call it I
could call it persons but in English we
typically say people so I'll call the
array people and I want two people to
exist in this array though I could
certainly change that number to be
anything I want how now do you put a
name inside of a person and then put the
number inside of that same person well
slightly new syntax today I'm going to
go ahead and say this people bracket
zero just gives me the first person in
the array that's not new but if you want
to go inside of that person in memory
you use a DOT and then you just specify
the name of the attribute therein so if
I want to set the first person's name to
Carter I just use that so-called dot
notation and then if I want to set
Carter's number using dot notation I
would do this plus one
617495 1000 and then if I want to do the
same for myself I would now do people
bracket
1name equals quote unquote David and
then people bracket one still number
equals quote unquote + 1
2750 and now at the bottom of my file I
think my logic can pretty much stay the
same I can still on this line here
prompt the user for the name of the
person they want to look up for now even
though I admit it's not the best design
I'm just doing this for demonstration
sake I'm going to leave the two there
because I know I have two people but
down here this is going to have to
change I don't want to compare names
bracket I anymore what do I want to type
here as the first first argument to stir
compare what do I want to do here
yeah so people i. name yeah so I want to
go into the people array at the I
location because that's what my Loop is
doing it's updating I again and again
and then look at name and that's good I
think now I need to change this too what
do I want to print if the person is
found someone
else what do I want to print here if I
found the person's name
yeah say a little
louder perfect so people bracket. number
if indeed I want to print the
corresponding number to this person and
then I think the rest of my code can
stay the same so let me go ahead and run
make phonebook to recompile this version
so far so good/ phonebook let's go ahead
and type in Carter's name found all
right let's go ahead and run it again
David's name found let's go ahead and
run it one more time type in John
Harvard for instance not found in this
case so fundamentally the code isn't all
that different linear search is still
behaving the same way and I admit this
is kind of ugly looking like we've kind
of made a two-line solution like five
lines of code now but if we fast forward
a week or two when we start saving
information to files uh we'll introduce
you to files like CSV value CSV files
comma separated values or spreadsheet
files which you've surely opened on your
Mac or PC at some point in the past
suffice it to say We'll soon learn
Techni for storing information like
names and numbers in files and at that
point we're not going to do any of this
hackish sort of hardcoding of the number
two and manually typing my name and
Carter's name and number into our
program we'll read the information
dynamically from a file and in a few
weeks we'll read it dynamically from a
database instead but this is for now
just syntactically how we can create an
array of size two containing one person
each we can update the name and number
of the first person update the name and
the number of the second person and then
later search across those names and
print out the corresponding numbers and
in this sense this is a better design
why because my person data type
encapsulates now everything that it
means to be a person at least in this
narrow world and if I want to add
something to the notion of a person for
instance I could go up to my typed Def
and tomorrow add an address to every
person and start reading that in as well
and now it's not the honor System it's
not a names array a numbers array and a
addesses array and everything else you
might imagine related to a person it's
all encapsulated which is a a term of
art inside of the same type reminiscent
if some of you have programmed before of
something called objectoriented
programming but we're not there yet C is
not that questions on this use of struct
or this new syntax the dot operator
being really the juicy part
here any questions
yeah
on what line
number 16 so yes so syntactically we
introduced the square brackets last week
so doing people bracket zero just means
go to the first person in the array that
was like when Stephanie literally opened
this door that's uh that's doors bracket
zero but this is of course people
bracket zero instead today the dot is a
new piece of syntax it means go inside
of that person in memory
and look at the name therein and set it
equal to Carter and do the same for
number so that's all it's like open the
locker door go inside of it and check or
set the name and the number
yeah attributes is fine uh good question
in the struct can you set default values
short answer no and this is where C
becomes less featurable than more more
modern languages like Python and Java
and others where you can in fact do that
so when we transition to python in a few
weeks time we'll see how we can start
solving problems like that but for now
it's up to you to initialize name and
number to something
yeah really good question how can we
adjust or critique the design of what
I'm doing
this is one of the few situations where
I would say hypocritically do as I say
not as I do I am using pretty ugly lines
like this just to introduce the syntax
but my claim pedagogically today is that
eventually when we start storing names
and numbers or other things in files or
in databases you won't have this
redundancy you'll have one line of code
or two lines of code that read the
information from the file or database
and then fill the entire array with that
data for now I'm just doing it manually
so is to keep our Focus only on the new
syntax but that's it so forgive the bad
Design By Design today other questions
on
this all right that's been a lot already
why don't we go ahead and take our
10-minute break with snacks first we
have some delightful brownies in the
lobby all right we are back and up until
now it clearly seems to be a good thing
if your data is sorted because you can
use binary search you know a little more
some little something more about the
data uh but it turns out that sorting of
itself is kind of a problem to solve too
and you might think well if sorting is
going to be pretty fast we absolutely
should do it before we start searching
because that'll just speed up all of our
searches but if sorting is slow that
kind of invites the question well should
we bother sorting our data if we're only
going to search the data maybe once
maybe twice and so here is going to be
potentially a trade-off so let's
consider what it means really to sort
data in our case it's just going to be
simple and use numbers but it might in
the case of the Googles of the World be
actual web pages or persons or the like
so here is our typical picture for
sorting input uh for solving any problem
input at left and output at right the
input to our sort problem is going to be
uh some unsorted set of values and the
output ideally will be the same set of
values sorted and if we do this
concretely let's suppose that we want to
go about sorting this list of numbers 7
2 5 4 1 6 03 so it's all of the numbers
from 0 to 7 but they're somehow jumbled
up randomly that's going to be the input
to the problem and the goal is now to
sort those so that you indeed get out 0
1 2 3 4 5 67 instead so it turns out
there's lots of different ways we can
actually sort numbers like these here um
and in fact just to complement our
search example earlier could we perhaps
quickly get some eight volunteers to
come up if you're comfortable appearing
on the internet if you want to do one
okay uh two three four five 6 7 eight
how about all right come on
down all
right come on over here and I'll give
you each a number and if you want to
start to organize yourselves in the same
order you see the numbers on the
board okay so look up on the overhead
and organize yourselves from left to
right in that same
order and let's have the first of you
perfect if you want to come uh right
over here
how about right in line with this all
right and a few more
numbers all right number
two six
and perfect just the right number all
right no uhoh all right there we go
number three all right so let's just do
a quick check we have 7 2 5 4 1 603 very
good so far do you want to just scooch a
little this way just to make a little
more of room all right and let's
consider now who we have here on stage
you want to each say a quick hello to
the audience hi my name is Ryan uh I'm a
first year from Penny
Packer hi my name is Cel I'm a first
year at Strauss um hi my name is Lucy
I'm a first year from
greo hi my name is Shiloh I'm a first
year in
Wigglesworth hi my name is Jack and I'm
a first year in
St hi my name is Katherine I'm a first
year in stra hi my name is Michael and
my first year at Penny Packer hi my name
is Muhammad at my first here in massuse
nice welcome aboard all right so let's
consider now how we might go about
sorting Our Kind volunteers here the
goal being to get them into order from
uh smallest to largest so that
presumably then we can use something
smarter than just linear search we could
actually use binary search assuming that
they are already then sorted so let me
propose that we first consider an
algorithm that actually has a name
called selection sort and selection sort
is going to be one that literally has me
or really you as the programmer
selecting the smallest element again and
again and then putting them into the
appropriate place so let me go ahead and
start this here uh starting with the
number seven at the moment seven is the
smallest number I found so I'm going to
make mental note of that with a mental
variable if you will I'm going to move
on now oh number two is obviously
smaller so I'm just going to update my
mental reminder that two is now the
smallest effectively forgetting for now
number seven uh five not smaller four
not smaller one smaller and I'm going to
make mental note of that six not smaller
zero smaller I'll make mental note of
that having forgotten now everything
else and now number three is not smaller
so what's your name again Michael so
Michael is number zero he belongs of
course way down there but unfortunately
you are Ryan Ryan Ryan is in the way so
what should we do how should we start to
sort this
list where should number zero
go yeah do you want to say the
L yeah so let's just go ahead and swap
so if you want to go ahead and zero go
on where seven is we need to make room
for number seven it would kind of be
cheating if maybe everyone kind of
politely stepped over to the side why
because if we imagine all of our
volunteers here to be in Array like
that's a crazy amount of work to have
every element in the array shift to the
left just to make room so we're going to
keep it simple and just evict whoever is
there now maybe we get lucky and number
seven is actually closer to its
destination maybe we get unlucky and it
goes farther away but we've at least
solved one problem if we had n problems
at first now we have n minus one because
number zero is indeed in the right place
so if I continue to act this out let me
go ahead and say two okay currently the
smallest five no four no one currently
the smallest I'll make mental note 6 7 3
and now let me pause one is obviously
the now smallest element so did I need
to keep going well it turns out at least
as I've defined selection sort I do need
to keep going because I only claim that
I'm using one variable in my mind to
remember the then smallest element I'm
not smart enough like us humans to
remember oh wait a minute one is
definitely the smallest now I don't have
that whole recollection so I just am
keeping track of the now smallest so
number one what your name was Jack Jack
where should jack go probably there and
what's your name itel itel okay so Jack
and itel if you want to swap places
we've now solved two of the end total
problems and now we'll do it a little
faster if each of you want to sort of
start to swap as I find the right person
so five smallest four is smaller two is
smaller got to keep checking okay two
was smaller all right now I'm going to
go back to the beginning all right four
is small five is not six is not seven is
oh three is small where do you want to
go okay good I'm going to go back here
and I can be a little smart I don't have
to go all the way to the end because I
know these folks are already sorted so I
can at least optimize slightly so now
five is small six is small seven is four
four is smaller if you want to go in
place
there and now here things get
interesting I can optimize by not
looking at these folks anymore more cuz
they're obviously problem solved but now
five is small six is not seven is not
okay five you can stay where you are now
a human in the room is obviously going
to question why I'm wasting any more
time but with selection sort as I've
defined it thus far I still have to now
check six is smallest not seven and now
my final step okay they're all in place
so here too is this dichotomy between
what we all have is this bird's eye view
of the whole problem where it's obvious
where everyone needs to go but a
computer implementing this with an array
really has to be more methodical and
we're actually saving a step here if we
were really doing this none of these
numbers would be visible all eight of
our volunteers would be inside of a
locked door and only then could we see
them one at a time but we're focusing
now just on the Sorting aspect so let me
just before we do one other
demonstration here proposed that what I
really just did here in pseudo code was
something like this 4 I from 0er to n
minus one keeping in mind that zero is
always the left of the array n minus one
is always the right end of of the array
for I from 0 to N minus1 I found the
smallest number between numbers bracket
I and numbers bracket n minus one and
that's the very geeky way of expressing
this optimization I'm always starting
from numbers bracket I wherever I am and
then everything else to the right and
that's what was allowing me to ignore
the already sorted volunteers if though
my last line says swap smallest number
with numbers I I think that implements
what our humans were doing by physically
walking to another spot all right so
that then would what we'll call
selection sort let's go ahead and take a
second approach here using an algorithm
that I'm going to call bubble sort but
to do this we need you all to reset to
your original locations we have a little
cheat sheet on the board if you'd like
to go back to this position here and let
me take a fundamentally different
approach because I'm not really liking
selection sort as is because it's kind
of a lot of walking back and forth and a
lot of walking suggests like a lot of
lot of steps again and again so what
might I do instead well bubble sort is
going to have me focus a little more
intuitively on just smaller problems and
let's see if this gets me somewhere else
so if I just look at this list without
looking at everyone else seven and two
this is obviously a problem why because
you're out of order so let's just solve
one tiny problem first so seven and two
why don't you swap I know two is in a
better place now because she's
definitely lower uh less than seven so I
think I can now move on seven and five
problem so let's solve that seven and
four problem let's solve that s and one
let's solve that 7 and six let's solve
that 7 and zero solve that 7 and three
solve that okay done sorted right all
obviously not if you just glance at
these numbers here but we have
fundamentally taken a bite out of the
problem seven is indeed in the right
place so we maximally have n minus one
other problems to solve so how do I do
this I think I can just repeat the same
logic let me go over here two and five
good five and four no five and one no
five and six yes 6 and zero no six and
three no so so now we've solved two of
the problems and what's nice about
Bubble sword at least as this glance
it's nice and simple it's nice and local
and you just keep incrementally solving
more and more problems so let's go ahead
and do this again and I'll do it we can
do it faster two and four we know are
good four and one four and five five and
zero five and three five and six six and
seven good so we go back two and one ah
now another problem solve two and four
four and zero four and three
four and five five and six six and seven
and so notice too as per its name the
largest elements have bubbled their way
up to the top and that's what seems to
be happening just as we're fixing some
remaining problems so almost done one
and two two and zero two and three three
and four four and five five and six six
and seven almost done obviously to us
humans it looks done how do I know as
the computer for sure what would be the
most Surefire way for me to now oh it's
not done sorry uh that's a bug
okay one and zero okay one and two two
and three three and four three four and
five five and six six and seven okay so
now it's obviously sorted to the rest of
us on stage how could I confirm as much
as code right you're doing it with your
mind just glancing at this how would the
computer the code know for sure that
this list is now sorted
yeah let's do one more time and look uh
draw what
conclusion yeah let's do it one more
time even though it's a little wasteful
but logically if I go through the whole
list comparing pairs again again and
again and I don't do any work that time
now it's obviously logically safe to
just stop because otherwise I'm wasting
my time doing the same thing again and
again if no one's actually moving so I'm
afraid we don't have Monopoly games for
all of you but we do have eight stress
balls and a round of applause if we
could for our
volunteers if you want to put your
numbers on the Shelf
there so if we consider for a moment
thank you thank you so
much
sure thank you thanks sure so if we
consider now these two algorithms which
one is better any intuition for whether
selection sort the first is better or
worse than bubble sort the
second any
thoughts
yeah okay so bubbl swort seemed like
less work especially since I was
focusing on those localized problems
other
intuition selection sort versus bubble
sort well let me propose that we try to
like quantize this so we can actually
analyze it in some way and this is not
an exercise we'll do constantly for lots
of algorithms but these are pretty
representative of algorithms so we can
wrap our minds around indeed the
performance or the design of these
things so here is my pseudo code for
selection sort whereby as it's as per
its name I just iteratively select the
next smallest element El again and again
so how can we go about analyzing
something like this well we could just
do it on paper pencil and count up the
number of steps that seem to be implied
logically by the code we could literally
comp count like the number of steps I
was taking again and again left to right
we could also just com uh count the
number of comparisons I was making with
each of the persons involved and I was
doing it kind of quickly in selection
sort but every time I was looking at a
person trying to decide do I want to
remember that number is small as that
number I was comparing two values with
an equals equals or less than or greater
than sign at least if we had done this
in code so that tends to be the norm
when analyzing algorithms like these
counting the number of comparisons
because it's kind of a global uh it's
kind of a global unit of measure we can
use to compare different algorithms
entirely so think too that in the
general case when we have more than
eight volunteers more than seven doors
we can generalize our our array in
general as this is the first element at
bracket zero and the end of it is always
n minus one so arrays uh or doors in
this case or volunteers are always
numerically indexed from zero on up to n
minus one if there's n of them in total
so how do we analyze the code of
selection sort well how many steps did
it take me to find the first smallest
element or more precisely how many
comparisons did I need to make when I
walked left to right to find our first
smallest person which ended up being
zero how many comparisons did I do when
walking left to right if there were
eight people on
stage how many total comparisons did I
do like if there's eight people I
compared these folks then then like this
person this person yeah yeah so seven
total right because if there's eight
people on stage you can only do seven
comparisons total because otherwise
you'd be comparing one number to itself
so it seems like in the general case if
you've got n numbers that you're trying
to sort finding the smallest element
first takes n minus one comparisons
maybe n it's total steps left or right
but the number of comparisons which I
claim is just a useful unit of measure
is n minus one how about finding the
next smallest person how many steps did
it take me to find the next smallest
number which ended up being the number
one
yeah yeah so just n minus two why
because I'd already solved one problem
someone was already in the right
position it would be silly to keep
counting them again and again so I can
Whittle down my number of comparisons
for the next past n minus 2 the third
past to find the third smallest number
would be n minus 3 and then dot dot dot
presumably this story this formula ends
when you have just one final pair the
people at the end to compare so if this
is looking a little reminiscent of some
kind of recurrence from high school or
high school math or physics or the like
let me just stipulate that if you
actually do out this math and generalize
it that is the same thing as n * nus1 /
2 and if you're Rusty on that no big
deal just kind of commit to memory that
anytime you add up this kind of series
something plus something slightly
smaller plus something slightly smaller
Each of which differs by one you're
going to get this formula n * n -1/ 2 if
we of course uh uh multiply that out
that's really n^ 2 minus n all divided
by two if we keep multiplying it out
that's n^2 / 2 minus n /2 and now we
have kind of a vocabulary with which we
can talk about the efficiency the design
of this algorithm but honestly I don't
really care about this level of
precision like n^2 / 2us n / 2 as n gets
really large which of these symbols
which of these terms is really going to
dominate become the biggest influencer
on the total value of
steps right it's the square right like
it's definitely not n divided by two
that's shaving some time off but N
squared as n gets big is going to get
really big if n is 100 then n squar is
bigger if N is a million n squ is really
bigger and so at the end of the day when
we really just talking about sort of a
wave of of the hand analysis and upper
bound if you will let's just say that
selection sort as analyzed here it's on
the order of n s steps it's not
precisely n squar steps but you know
what n^2 divided two the intuition here
might be that well it's half of that you
n squ is what really matters as n gets
really really large and that's when you
start thinking about and trying to solve
the Google problems of the world when n
gets large that's when you have to be
smarter than just sort of naive
implementations of any algorithm so
where then does this algorithm fall into
this categorization here well n^2 it
turns out is on the order of n squ steps
in the worst case whether it's sorted or
not it turns out though lower bound if
we consider this same code suppose the
best case scenario like our eight
volunteers came up on stage and just
because they already sorted themselves 0
through seven suppose they just happen
to be in that state how many steps would
selection store
take to sort an already sorted list of
volunteers any intuition
yeah would it still be
n so for the first pass it would still
be seven for the first per uh pass
across the humans because even though
yeah I'm claiming zero is here I don't
know that zero is the smallest until I
make my way all the way over there doing
all seven comparisons okay fine first
pass took seven more generally n minus
one steps what if I look for the next
smallest element and the humans in this
story are already sorted 0 through 7
well yes the number one's here and I see
them first but I don't know they're the
smallest until I compare against
everyone else get to the end of the list
oh well that was stupid I already had
the smallest person in hand then and so
this pseudo code this implementation of
selection sort is sort of fixed like
this there's no special case that says
if already sorted quit early it's always
going to take n squ steps and so in this
case if we borrow our uh jargon from
earlier using Omega notation just to be
clear selection sword is also going to
be in this Incarnation on an Omega of n
s because even in the best case where
the list is already sorted you're going
to waste a huge amount of time
essentially verifying as much or
discovering as much even though we
humans of course could see it right away
so selection sort would seem to take
both N squared steps in the uh worst
case n s steps in the best case and so
you know what we can use our Theta
terminology for that here would be an
algorithm just like counting earlier
that always takes N squared steps no
matter whether the array is sorted or
not from the get-go all right so
hopefully we can do better and someone
proposed earlier that bubble sort felt
like it was using fewer steps well let's
consider that next with bubble sort we
had this pseudo code I claim whereby
let's focus on the inside of the code
first down here what was I doing for I
from 0 to n minus 2 that's curious we've
never seen n minus 2 before but I asked
this question if numbers bracket I and
numbers bracket I + 1 are out of order
swap them so that was when I was
pointing at our first two volunteers
here I saw that they were out of order
so I swapped them how come I'm doing
that again and again up to nus 2 though
instead of n
minus1 which we've always used up until
now as our rightmost
boundary any intuition for why I'm doing
this from 0 to n minus 2
yeah exactly because I'm looking at the
E person per this pseudo code here and
the E plus one person I better make sure
I don't go Step Beyond the at boundaries
of my array so if you think of like my
left hand when my back was two here
pointing at the current person at the
first position my right hand for this if
conditioner is essentially pointing at
the person next to them and you want to
iterate with your left hand all through
these people but you don't want your
left hand to point at the last person
you want it to point at the second to
last person but we know that the last
person is always at n minus one so the
second to last person just
mathematically is at n minus 2 so it's a
subtlety but this is like a Segal
waiting to happen if you implemented
bubble sort using n minus one you will
my right hand would go beyond the
boundaries of the array so just bad all
right so why am I saying this end times
Well we did it very organically with
humans but each time someone uh each
pass I did through the array someone
bubbled their way up to the end number
seven then number six then number five
so if on each pass through the array of
volunteers I was solving at Mo at least
one problem it seems like bubble sort
can just run n times total to solve all
n problems cuz the first pass will get
at least one one number into place
second pass second number into place you
might get lucky and it would do more but
worst case this feels like enough just
do this blindly end times and they'll
all line up together well technically
all right now we're getting into the
weeds technically you can just repeat it
n minus one times because if you solve
all n minus one other problems and
you're left with one like literally that
person's where they need to be just
logically if you've already sorted
everything else and you've got just the
one left it's already bubbled up so how
do we analyze this well in bubble sore
we might do something like this I'm
essentially doing n minus one Things N
minus one times now let me back up to
the pseudo code because this one's a
little less obvious this is where you
can actually mathematically infer from
your Loop uh how many steps you're
taking so this first line literally says
repeat the following n minus one times
so that's going to translate very
straightforwardly to our mathematical
formula do something n minus one times
this Loop just because I'm using four
Loop terminology it's framed a little
differently but but if you're iterating
from 0 to nus 2 you're iterating a total
of nus1 times and again the arithmetic
is getting a little annoying but this
just means do the following n minus one
times so do n minus one Things N minus
one times we can now uh run out the math
as follows we have the formula n minus1
* n minus1 we do our little foil method
here N2 -1 * N - 1 * n + 1 we can
combine like terms n^ 2 - 2 n plus one
but at this point when n gets really
large which term are we really going to
care about this is on the order
of yeah n s so at least ASM totically
ASM totically means as n approaches
Infinity gets really large turns out
that the upper bounds on selection sort
and bubble sort are essentially the same
now if we really nitpicked and compared
the total number of comparisons they
might differ slightly but as n gets
large honestly you're barely going to
notice the difference it would seem
between these two algorithms
but what about um the lower bound if the
upper bound on Bubble sword is also Big
O of n what about the lower bound here
well with this pseudo code what would
the lower bound be on bubble sort even
in the best case when all of the
volunteers are
sorted any
intuition in this pseudo code yeah in
the
middle
good question isn't bubble sorts
designed such that you wouldn't need to
compare numbers that have already uh
bubbled up that's what's happening here
in the middle implicitly I'm always
going from left to right but remember
that even when I screwed up at the end
and the last two people were out of
order I do always need to restart at the
beginning because the big numbers are
going that way and the small numbers are
coming this
way so that is true there are some
slight optimizations that I'm kind of
glossing over here let me stipulate that
it would still end up being on the order
of n squ but that would definitely shave
off some actual running time here but
what if the list is already sorted our
our pseudo code at the moment has no
allowance for if list is already sorted
quit early so we're going to blindly do
n minus one Things N minus one times
unless we modify our pseudo code as I
did verbally earlier I propose this
inside of that outer loop if you make a
pass across all of the volunteers and
your mental counter has made no swaps
you have to keep track with some kind of
variable well then you might as well
stop because if you do a whole pass and
make no swaps why would you waste time
doing it again expecting different
Behavior so to help visualize these
whereby now bubble sort can be
advantageous if the data is already
sorted or mostly sorted why because it
does have this short circuit detail at
least if we implement it like that how
can we go about um visualizing these
things a little more clearly well let me
go ahead and do this let me pull up here
a visualization of exactly these
algorithms thanks to a third party tool
here that's going to help us visualize
these sorting algorithms as follows
small bars represent small numbers big
bars represent big numbers and so the
idea now is when I hit a button here to
get all of the small bars this way all
of the big bars this way so just like
our volunteers but instead of holding
lighted numbers its bars representing
their magnitude so let's go ahead and
start with for instance select
sort and you'll see in pink is being
highlighted the current number that is
being selected and then pulled all the
way to the left so this is selection
sort and again it's selecting the next
smallest element but you can see here
all the more visibly that just like my
human feet were taking a lot of steps so
is this algorithm touching these
elements again and again and again and
this is why the N squ is really a thing
there's got to be some inherent
redundancy here like why do we keep
looking at the same darn elements again
and again we do in terms of our pseudo
code need to do so but it's this
redundant comparisons that kind of
explains why n s is indeed the case so
now it's done small bars here big bars
there and I had to just keep talking
there to kill time because it's
relatively slow well let me randomize
the array just so we start with a
different order and now let me click on
bubbl sore and you'll see similar idea
but different algorithm so now the two
bars in pink are the two that are being
compared and fixed potentially if
they're out of order and you can see
already that the biggest bars are
bubbling their way up to the top but now
you can also see like this redundancy
like we keep swooping through the list
again and again just like I kept walking
back and forth and this is n squar this
is not that many bars what 10 20 there's
like 40 or something bars I'm guessing
that's pretty slow already just to sort
40 numbers and I think it's going to get
tedious if I keep talking over this so
let's just assume that this two is
relatively slow had I gotten lucky and
the list were almost sorted already
bubble sort would have been pretty fast
but this was a truly random array so we
did not get lucky so indeed the worst
case might be what's kicking in here so
I don't I feel like it'll be
anticlimactic like holding in a sneeze
if I don't let you see the end of this
so here we go nothing interesting is
about to happen almost
done ah okay done all right so thank you
thank
you so still somewhat slow though how
though can we perhaps do a little better
fundamentally so we can do so if we
introduce yet another technique and this
one isn't so much a function of code as
it is concept and it's something that
you might have seen in the real world um
but perhaps not so obviously so so it
turns out in programming recursion
refers to the ability of a function to
call itself in the world of mathematics
if you have a function f if F appears on
both the left side and the right side of
a formula that would be a recursive
function in the math world too whenever
f is defined in terms of itself or in
our case in Compu in programming anytime
a function calls itself that function is
said to be recursive and this is
actually something we've seen already in
class even though we didn't call it as
much so for instance consider this
pseudo code um from earlier whereby this
was the pseudo code for searching via AR
search a whole bunch of doors if no
doors are left return false that was the
the additional conditional we added but
then if number behind middle door return
true and here's the interesting part if
number is less than middle door search
the left half else if number is greater
than middle door search the right half
this pseudo code earlier was itself
recursive why because here is an
algorithm for searching but what's the
algorithm telling us well on this line
and this line it's telling us to search
something else so even though it's not
explicitly defined in code as having a
name if this is a search algorithm and
yet the search algorithm is using a
search algorithm this pseudo code is
recursive now that could quickly get you
into trouble if a function just calls
itself again and again and again but why
intuitively is it not problematic that
this code this pseudo code calls
itself why will the algorithm still stop
yeah
exactly it has some exit condition like
if no do is less and more more
importantly anytime you search the left
half you're searching a smaller version
of the problem anytime you search the
right half you're searching a smaller
version of the problem literally half
the size so this is why in the phone
book obviously I couldn't tear the phone
book in half uh infinitely many times
because it was literally getting smaller
each time so recursion is this ability
to call yourself if you will it's but
what's important is that you do it on a
small smaller smaller problem so that
eventually you have no more problems to
solve or no more data no more doors at
all so these two lines here would be the
recursive elements here but if we go
back to week zero we could have used
recursion in some other way so this was
our Cudo code for the phone book back in
week zero and recall that we described
these yellow lines as really
representing a loop some kind of cycle
again and again but there was a missed
opportunity here what if I had reinvent
reimplemented this code to do this
instead
instead of saying open to middle of left
half of book and then go back to line
three like literally inducing a loop or
open to Middle right half a book and go
back to line three inducing another loop
why don't I just recognize that what I'm
staring at now is a algorithm for
searching a phone book and if you want
to search a smaller phone book like a
through M or n through Z we'll just use
the same algorithm so I can replace
these yellow lines with just this
casually speaking search left half a
book search right half a book this would
be implicitly and now I can shorten the
whole thing a recursive implementation
of the phone book pseudo code from week
zero and it's recursive because if this
is a search algorithm and you're saying
go search something else that's fine
that's recursive but because you're
searching half of the phone book it's
indeed going to get smaller and smaller
even in the real world or the real
virtual world you can see recursive data
structures in the wild or at least in
Super Mario Brothers like this let me
get rid of all the distractions here and
focus on this pyramid where you have one
block then two then three then four well
this itself is technically recursively
defined in the sense that well what is a
pyramid of height four well it's really
what how would you describe a pyramid of
height four is actually the same thing
as a pyramid
of of of height three plus one
additional layer well what's a pyramid
of height three well it's technically a
pyramid of height two plus one
additional layer and so even physical
structures can be recursive if you can
Define them in terms of itself now at
some point you have to say that if the
pyramid is of height one there's just
one block you can't forever say it's
defined in terms of a height negative 1
negative2 you would never stop so you
have to kind of have a special case
there but let's go ahead and translate
something like this in fact to code let
me go back to uh vs code here and let me
Implement a program called iteration
that refers to a loop iterating and let
me Implement a very simple pyramid like
that so let me go ahead and include the
cs50 library I'll include our standard
i.h in main void no command line
arguments today and let's go ahead and
do this let's declare a variable called
height ask the human for the height of
this pyramid and then let's go ahead and
draw a pyramid of that height now of
course draw does not yet exist so I'm
going to need to invent the draw a
function let me go ahead and Define a
function that doesn't have a return
value it's just going to have side
effects it's just going to print bricks
on the screen call draw and it takes in
an integer n as its input and how am I
going to implement this well again I
want to print one block then two then
three then four that's pretty
straightforward at least once you're
comfortable with loops let me go back to
the code here let me go ahead and say 4
into I gets zero I is less than n i ++
and that's going to iterate essentially
row by row and on each row I want to
print out one then two then three then
four bricks but I'm iterating from Z to
1 to two to three so I think that's okay
I can just say something like 4 in J
gets zero J Let's Be Clever about this
is less than I
j++ and now let me go ahead and inside
of this loop I think I can get away with
just printing out a single hash sign but
then outside of that Loop similar to
last week I'm going to print my new line
separately so a little non-obvious at
first but this outer loop iterates row
by row line by line if you will and then
the inner loop just Mak sure that when I
equals zero um let's see oh nope there's
a bug I need to make sure that it's j is
less than I + 1 so when I is zero on my
first line of output I'm going to print
out one brick when I is one I'm going to
print out two bricks and so forth so let
me go ahead and run make iteration
all right and now seems to compile
uhoh huh implicit Declaration of
function draw so I'm making week one
mistakes
again what say
again yeah the the Prototype is missing
I didn't declare it at the top that's an
easy fix and the only time really it's
okay and necessary to copy paste let me
copy the functions declaration there end
it with a semicolon so that clang now
knows that draw will exist make
iteration now it works thank you /
iteration we'll type in something like
four and there we have it our pyramid of
height 1 2 3 4 that looks pretty similar
to this albeit using hashes so that's
how we would have implemented this like
two weeks ago in week one maybe last
week but just using arrays but let me
propose that we could do something
recursively instead let me close this
version of the code and let me go back
to VSS code and open up recursion doc
just to demonstrate something
recursively and I'll do it incorrectly
deliberately the first time so let me
include cs50.h let me include standard
i.h let me do uh int main void and let
me just blindly draw a pyramid initially
of height one but now in my draw
function let me reimplement it a little
differently so my draw function this
time is still going to take a number n
but that's how many hashes it's going to
print so let's do four into I gets zero
I is less than n i
++ then let's go ahead and print out a
single hash mark here and then after
that let's print out the end of the line
just as before but now this of course is
only going to draw a single um row it's
going to print out one hash or two
hashes or three hashes but only on one
line let me now incorrectly but just
kind of curiously say all right well if
this draws a pyramid of height one let's
just use ourself to draw a pyramid of
height n plus one so the first time I
call draw it will print out one hash
then the second time I call draw it will
print out two hashes then three then
four so we're kind of laying These
Bricks down from top to bottom uh make
recursion uh oops I screwed up again so
let's copy the Prototype here let's put
this down over here semicolon let's do
this again uh make recursion all right
all good/ recursion and now let me
increase the size of my terminal window
just so you can see more of the output
and here we
have okay bad but thank you so we have
an infinitely tall pyramid and it's just
flying across the screen which is why it
looks kind of like a mess but I printed
out a pyramid of height one and then two
and then three and then four and
unfortunately what am I lacking any sort
of quick condition any kind of condition
that says wait a minute when it's too
tall stop all together so this is an
infinite Loop but it's not a loop it's a
recursive call and actually doing this
in en is very bad we'll see next week
that if you call a function too many
times you can actually trigger yet one
yet another of those segmentation faults
cuz you're using too much memory
essentially but for now I haven't
triggered that yet control C is your
friend to cancel and as an aside if
you're playing along at home or play
with this code later I actually cheated
here we have a special clang
configuration feature that prevents you
from calling a function like that and
creating a problem I overrode it just to
for demonstration sake but odds are at
home you wouldn't be able to compile
this code yourself but let me do a
proper version recursively of this code
as follows let me go back into the code
here let me go ahead and not just
blindly start drawing one then two then
three layers of bricks let me prompt the
human as before for the height of the
pyramid they want using our get in
function and now let me call draw of
height again so now I'm going back to
the looplike version but instead of
using a loop now this is where recursion
gets rather elegant if you will let me
go ahead and execute and code uh the
draw function as
follows per your definition if a pyramid
of height four is really just a pyramid
of height three plus another row well
let's take that literally let me go back
to my code and if you want to draw a
pyramid of height four well go right
ahead and draw a pyramid of height uh
three first or more generally n minus
one but what's the second step well once
you've drawn a pyramid of height three
draw an extra row so I at least have to
bite off that part of the problem myself
so let me just do for in I gets zero I
is less than n i++ and let me the
programmer of this function print out my
hashes and then at the very bottom print
out a new line so the cursor moves to
the next line but this is kind of
elegant now I dare say in that draw is
recursive because I'm literally
translating from English to code this
idea that a pyramid of height four is
really just a pyramid of height three so
I do that first and I'm sort of trusting
that this will work then I just have to
lay one more layer of bricks four of
them so if n is four this is just a
simple for Loop Allah week one that will
print out an additional layer but this
of course is going to be problematic
eventually why it's not done yet this
program how many times will draw call
itself in this
model infinitely many times
why yeah there's no there's no
equivalent of quit like if you've
printed enough already then quit well
how do we capture that well I don't
think we want this to go negative right
it would make no sense to draw a
negative height pyramid so I think we
can just pluck off as the programmer a
an easy case an easy answer a so-called
base case and I'm just going to do this
at the top of my draw function let me
just say if n is less than or heck less
than or equal to zero that's it go ahead
and just return there's nothing more to
do and that simple condition technically
known as a base case will ensure that
the code doesn't run forever why well
suppose that draw uh is called with an
argument of four four is of course not
less than zero so we don't return but we
do draw a pyramid of height three and
here's where things get a little
mentally tricky you don't move on to
line 20 until draw has been called so
when draw is called with an argument of
three it's as though you're executing
from the top of this function again
three is not less than zero so what do
you do you draw two okay how do you draw
two well two is not less than zero so
you don't return so you draw one got to
be careful here draw one and now we go
ahead back to the beginning how do you
draw One well one is not less than zero
so you don't return you draw height zero
how do you draw height zero wait a
minute 0o is less than or equal to zero
and you return and so it's kind of like
this mental stack this to-do list you
keep postponing executing these lower
lines of code because you keep
restarting restarting restarting the
draw function until finally one of those
function calls says there's nothing to
do return and now the whole thing starts
to unravel if you will and you pick back
up where you left off and this is
perhaps the best uh scenario we won't do
it in class but if you'd like to wrestle
through this on your own using debug 50
to keep stepping into step into step
into each of those lines logically
you'll see exactly what's actually
happening so let me go to my terminal
and do make recursion which is now this
correct version of the code do/
recursion let's type in a height of four
and voila now we have that same pyramid
not using iteration per se though
admittedly we're using iteration to
print the additional layer we're now
using draw recursively to print all of
the smaller pyramids that need come
before
it no question is can you only use
recursion with a void function no not at
all in fact it's very common to have a
return value like an integer or
something else so that uh you can
actually do something constructively
with that actual value other questions
on
this say a little
lad when is line 21 getting executed so
if you continue to UNR let me uh scroll
down a bit more so you can see the top
of the code so line 21 will be executed
once line 19 is done executing itself
now in the story I told we kept calling
draw again again again but as soon as
one of those function calls where n
equals z returns immediately then we
don't keep drawing again and again so
now if you kind of think of the process
as reversing then you continue to line
21 then a line 21 again then line 21
again and as the sort of logic unravels
and next week we'll actually paint a
picture of what's actually happening in
the computer's memory but for now it's
just it's very similar to the pseudo
code for the phone book you're just
searching again and again but you're
waiting until the very end to get back
the final result uh can Google Now whom
I keep mentioning by coincidence today
is full of programmers of course um
here's a fun exercise let me uh go back
to a browser I'm going to go ahead and
search for recursion because I want to
learn a little something about recursion
uh here is kind of an internet meme or
joke if I zoom in here the engineers at
Google are kind of funny funny see
why ah there we go yes yes this is
recursion and there's going to be so
many memes you'll come across now where
recursion like if you've ever pointed a
camera at the TV that's showing the
camera and you sort of see yourself for
the image again and again that's really
recursion and in that case it only stops
once you hit the base case of a single
Pixel um but this is a very funny joke
in some circles uh when it comes to
recursion uh and Google so how can we
actually use Google or rather how can we
actually use recursion constructively
well let me propose that we actually
introduce a third and final algorithm
for sorting that hopefully does better
than the two sorts thus far we've done
selection sort and bubble sort bubble
sort we liked a little better at least
in so far is in the best case where the
list is already sorted bubble sort is at
least smarter and it will actually
terminate early giving us a better lower
Bound in terms of our Omega notation but
it turns out that recursion and this is
not necessarily a feature of recursion
but something we can now leverage it
turns out using recursion we can take a
fundamentally different approach to
sorting a whole bunch of numbers in such
a way that we can do far fewer
comparisons and ideally speed up our
final results so here is the pseudo code
for what we're about to see for
something called merge sort and it
really is this tur sort the left half of
numbers sort the right half of numbers
merge the sorted halves right this is
almost sort of non sensical because I uh
if you're asked for an algorithm to sort
and you respond with well sort the left
half sort the right half like that's
being sort of difficult because well I'm
asking you for a sorting algorithm
you're just telling me to sort the left
half and the right half but implicit in
that last line merging is a pretty
powerful feature of this sort now we do
need another base case at the top so let
me add this if we find ourselves with a
list an array of size one well that
array is obviously sorted if there's
only one element in it there's no work
to be done so that's going to be our
base case but allowing us now in just
these what uh four six lines of pseudo
code to actually sort some elements but
let's focus first on just a subset of
this let's consider for a moment what it
means to merge sorted have so Carter has
wonderfully come up to volunteer here
just to help us reset these numbers
suppose that in the middle of the story
we're about to tell we have two sorted
halves I've already sorted the left half
of these numbers and indeed 2 4 57 is
sorted from smallest to largest and the
right half appears to be already sorted
0136 already sorted so in my pseudo code
we're already done sorting the left half
and the right half somehow but we'll see
how in a moment well how do I go about
merging these two halves well because
they're sorted already and you want to
merge them in order I think we can flip
down we can hide all but the first
numbers in each of these subl lists so
here we have a half that starts with two
and I don't really care what the other
numbers are because they're clearly
larger than two I can focus only on Two
And Z too zero also we know that zero is
the smallest there so let's just ignore
the numbers that Carter kindly flipped
down so how do I merge these two lists
into a new sorted larger list well I
compare the two on my left with the zero
on my right obviously which comes first
the zero so let me put this down here
and Carter if you want to give us the
next element now I have two sorted
halves but I've already plucked one off
so now I compare the two against the one
one obviously comes next so I'm going to
take out the one and put it in place
here now I'm going to compare the two
halves again two and three which do I
merge first obviously the two comes next
and now notice each time I do this my
hands are theoretically making forward
progress I'm not doubling back like I
kept doing with selection sort or bubble
sort back and forth back and forth my
fingers are constantly advancing forward
and that's going to be a key detail so I
compare four and three three obviously I
compare three and uh I compare four and
six four obviously I compare five five
and six five obviously and then I
compare seven and six six of course and
then lastly we have just one element
left and even though I'm kind of moving
awkwardly as a human my hands
technically were only moving to the
right I was never looping back doing
something again and again and that's
perhaps the intuition and just enough
room for the seven so that then is how
you would merge two sorted halves we
started with left half sorted right half
sorted and merging is just like what you
would do as a human and Carter just
flips the numbers down so our Focus was
only on the smallest elements in each
any questions before we Forge ahead with
what it means then to be merged in this
way so now here is an original list we
deliberately put it at the top because
there's one detail of Mer sort that's
key mer sort is technically going to use
a little more space and so whereas
previously we just kept moving our
humans around and swapping people and
making sure they stayed ultimately in
the original positions with mer sort
pretend ends that here's our original
array of uh memory I'm going to need at
least one other array of memory and I'm
going to cheat and I'm going to use even
more memory but technically I could
actually go back and forth between one
array and a secondary array but it isn't
going to it is going to take me more
space so how do I go about implementing
merge sort on this Al on this code well
let's consider this here's a array of
size eight if only one number quit
obviously not applicable so let's focus
on the juicy part there sort the left
half of the numbers all right how do I
sort the left half of the numbers I'm
going to just nudge them over just to be
clear which is the left half how here is
now a sub list of size four how do I
sort the left
half well do I have an algorithm for
sorting yeah what do I do here's a list
of size four how do I sort it what's
step one sort the left half so I now
sort of conceptually in my mind take
this sublist of size four and I sort it
by first sorting the left half focusing
now on the seven and two all right
here's a list of size two how do I sort
a list of size
two sorry I think we just keep following
our instruction sort the left half all
right here is a list of size one how do
I sort a list of size
one I'm done like it's done so I leave
this alone what was the next step in the
story I've just sorted the left half of
the left half of the left half what
comes next I sort the right half of the
left half of the left half and I'm done
cuz it's just a list of size one what
comes after this merge so this is where
it gets a little trippy because you have
to remember where we're pausing the
story to do things recursively again and
again but if I've just sorted the left
half and I've just sorted the right half
now I merge them together this is a
super short list so we don't need um uh
Carter's help here as before but I think
the first number I take here is the two
and then the second number I take
because it's the only option is the
seven but what's nice now is that notice
the left half of the left half is indeed
sorted because I trivially sorted the
left half of it and the right half of it
but then merging is really where the
magic happens all right again if you rem
if you rewind now in your mind if I've
just sorted the left half of the left
half what happens
next sort the right half of the left
half so again you kind of rewind in time
so how do I do this I've got a list of
size two I sort the left half the just
the five done sort the right half four
done now the interesting part I merge
the left half and the right half of the
right half of the left half so what do I
do four comes down here five comes down
here and
now notice what I have left half is
sorted right half is sorted if you
rewind in time where is my next step
three merge the two halves and so this
is what Carter helped me do before let's
focus only on the smallest elements just
so there's less distraction I compare
the two and the four two comes first so
let's obviously put that here now I
compare the new beginning of this list
and the old beginning of this list four
obviously comes next and now I compare
the seven against the five five
obviously comes next and now lastly I'm
left with one number so now I'm down to
the seven so even if you've kind of lost
track of some of the nuances here if you
just kind of take a step back we have
the original right half here still
untouched but the left half of the
original input is now indeed sorted all
by way of doing sorting left half right
half left half right half but with those
merges in between all right so if we've
just sorted the left half we rewind all
the way to the beginning what do I now
do all right so sort the right half so
sort the right half how do I sort a list
of size four well I first sort the left
half the one and the six how do I sort a
list of size two you sort the left half
just the number one obviously there's no
work to be done done sorting the left
half six done sorting the right half now
what do I do I merge the left half here
with the right half here and that one's
pretty straightforward now what do I do
I've just merged so now I sorted I've
just sorted the left half of the right
half so now I sort the right half of the
right half so I consider the zero done I
consider the three done I now merge
these two together zero of course comes
first then comes the three and now I'm
at the point of the story where I've
sorted the left half of the right half
and the right half of the right half so
step three is merge and I'll do it again
like we did with Carter all right one
and zero obviously the zero comes first
now compare the one and the three
obviously the one comes first compare
the six and the three obviously the
three and then lastly the sixth so now
where are we we've taken the left half
of the whole thing and sorted the left
and sorted it we then took the right
half of the whole thing and sorted it so
now we're at lastly step three for the
last last time what do we do merge and
so just to be consistent let me push
these down and let's compare left hand
to right hand noticing that they only
make forward progress none of this back
and forth comparisons two and zero of
course the zero so we'll put that in
place two and one of course the one so
we put that in place two and three we
merge in of course the two in this case
four and three we now merge in the three
in this case four and six we now merge
of course the four in place and now we
compare five and six we keep the
five
bug okay well pretend that the five is
on uh oh this is why all right so now we
compare the seven and the six sixth is
gone and lastly seven is the last one in
place and even though I grant that of
all the algorithms this is probably the
hardest one to stay on top of especially
when I'm doing it as a voiceover realize
that what we've just done is only those
three steps recursively we started with
a list of size eight we sorted the left
half we sorted the right half and then
we merged the two together but if you go
down each of those rabbit holes so to
speak sorting the left half involves
sorting the left half of the left half
and the right half of the left half and
so forth but this germ of an idea of
really dividing and conquering the
problem not such that you're having the
problem and only dealing with one half
clearly we're sorting one half and the
other half and merging them together
ultimately it does still lead us to the
same solution and if we visualize the
remnants of this now if I depict this as
follows where on the screen here you see
where the numbers originally started in
the top row from left to right
essentially even though this is in a
different order I divided that list of
size eight ultimately into eight lists
of size one and that's where the base
case kicked in and just said okay we're
done sorting that and after that
logically I then sorted I merged two
lists of size one into many lists of
size two and those lists of size two
into lists of size four and then finally
the list of size four into one big list
sorted of size eight and so I put forth
this picture with the little line
indicators here because how many times
did I divide divide divide in half or
really double double double so exponent
is the opposite oh spoiler uh how many
times did I divide so three concretely
but if there's eight elements total and
there's N More generally it really is a
matter of dividing and conquering login
times you start this and you can divide
one two three times login times or
conversely you can start here and
exponentially uh double double double
three times which is log n but on every
row every shelf literally I made a fuss
about pointing my hands only from the
left to the right constantly advancing
them such that every time I did those
merges I touched every element once and
only once there was none of this back
and forth back and forth on stage so if
I'm doing something log n times if I'm
doing rather N Things log n times what
would be our Big O formula perhaps N
Things log n
times yeah so n log n the order of n log
n is indeed how we would describe the
running time of merge sort and so of all
of the sorts thus far we've seen that
merge sort here actually is n log n
which is strictly better than n squ
which is where both merge uh both
selection sort and bubble sort landed
but it's also slower than linear search
for instance but you would rather expect
that if you have to do a lot of work up
front sorting some elements versus just
searching them you're going to have to
put in more effort and so the question
of whether or not you should just search
something blindly with linear search and
not bother sorting it really boils down
to can you afford to spend this amount
of time and if you're the Googles of the
world odds are you don't want to be
searching their database linearly every
time why because you can sort it once
and then benefit millions billions of
people subsequently using something like
binary search or frankly in practice
something even fancier and faster than
binary search but there's always going
to be this tradeoff you can achieve
binary search only if the elements are
sorted how much does it cost you to sort
them well maybe N squared if you use
some of the earlier algorithms but it
turns out n log n is pretty fast as well
so at the end of the day
these running times involve tradeoffs
and indeed in merge sort 2 I should note
that the lower bound on merge sort is
also going to be Omega of n log n as
such we can describe it in terms of our
Theta notation saying that merge short
is indeed in Theta of n log n so
generally speaking probably better to
use something like merge sort or some
other algorithm that's in N log n in
practice most programmers are not
implementing these sorting algorithms
themselves odds are they're using a
library off the shelf that themselves
have made the decision as to which of
these algorithms to do but generally
speaking and we're seeing now this for
the first time if you want to improve
time like use less time write faster
code you got to pay a price and that
might be your human time just takes you
more time to code up something more
sophisticated more difficult to
implement or you need to spend something
like space and as these shelves suggest
that too is one of the key details of
merge sort you can't just have the
elements swapping in place you need at
least an auxiliary array so that when
you do the merging you have a place to
put them and this is excessive this
amount of memory I could have just gone
back and forth between top shelf and
bottom shelf but it's a little more
interesting to go top down but you do
need more space back in the day decades
ago space was really expensive and so
you know what it might have been better
to not use merge sort use bubble sort or
uh selection sort even or some other
algorithm alog together nowadays space
is relatively cheap and so these are
more acceptable trade-offs but it
totally depends on the application the
very last thing we thought we'd do is
show you an actual compar comparison of
some of these sorting algorithms it's
about 60 seconds long and it will
compare for you uh selection sort bubble
sort and merge sort in parallel
simultaneously uh with some fun sorting
music showing you ultimately what it
really means to be an O of n s or better
yet Big O of n
Logan selection on the top bubble on the
bottom merge in the
[Music]
middle
[Applause]
[Music]
all right that's it for cs50 we'll see
you next
[Music]
time
e
[Music]
all right this is cs50 and this is week
four and if you think back a few weeks
ago already in week zero we started
talking about like what images are and
we talked about representation of images
as this grid of pixels and each pixel
has like some pattern of bits that
defines its color well it turns out
today we'll take a deeper look
underneath the hood at how things like
images and so much more is actually
implemented using just these zeros and
ones and how now as a programmer you can
actually harness that for better for
worse to better understand and better
manipulate what's going on inside of a
computer's memory using a language like
C in fact even this bowl of stress balls
that we keep happening is just a
photograph of course but if you think
back to week zero if you sort of enhance
enhance enhance this image like they do
in the movies it actually doesn't work
out the way you would think from
Hollywood as I keep continue to zoom in
and zoom in and zoom in on a screen like
this you'll see that yes it gets bigger
but if it gets too big what do you start
to notice the so-called pixelation and
indeed you can see the individual dots
so next time you watch some uh show or
movie on uh TV that has this sort of
notion of enhancing you know there's
actually a finite limit there you can
only enhance so far as there's actually
information there but once you zoom in
to a certain level like this like that's
all that there you're not going to see
the glint of the suspect in some crime
drama in their eye just because you've
enhanced the image there's only a finite
amount of information actually there but
we'll see today too that by
understanding what's going on inside of
a computer's memory we can start to
represent and even create and code more
interesting things so for instance here
is a bit map if you will which is a term
of art a bit map is a type of image and
it's a map of bits in the sense that you
have this coordinate system of up top
down left right at least in this artist
representation here and suppose that
maybe we all defi decide as a as as the
world that one shall represent the color
white and zero shall represent the color
black what might this map of bits this
bit map actually be can you see through
it yeah it is indeed a smiley face so an
amazing eye if I actually turn all of
the ones to White just to visualize this
you'll see indeed this is what was
embedded there but of course on our
computer monitors and phones we have
this grid of square is this grid of
pixels so indeed if you were to actually
see on your screen a smiley face like a
black and white one at that what's
probably going on underneath the hood is
just some pattern of zeros and ones and
maybe single bits one bit color if you
will where one here represents white and
zero represents black so if you kind of
like this thing it turns out you can do
pretty uh pretty beautiful pretty
interesting pretty artistically inclined
things if you go to this URL at your
leisure cs50. lart it'll actually
redirect you to a Google spreadsheet
that we've made in advance and we've
kind of Shrunk the rows and columns to
resemble a grid of pixels tiny little
squares all of which are white by
default not unlike this easel here that
we have a couple of volunteers working
away at in fact would you guys like to
come forward for a moment and say a
quick hello before we come back to you
uh hello my name is Daniel I'm from
Chicago welcome to Daniel and hi
everyone I'm Adam and I'm from chindon
Tobago nice well welcome to you both
thank you you'll see that in their hands
are actually a whole bunch of pixels uh
Post-it notes that we've handed them in
in advance so if you don't mind we'll
come back to you in a couple of minutes
and see what they've created if you will
on this grid of white paper much like
you could create on this Google
spreadsheet in fact feel free to send us
your Creations if so inclined uh via the
URL you'll get at cs50. lart now let's
come back to week zero where we Define
some of the building blocks for images
we talked about RGB which is just red
green blue and it's just one of the
systems a popular system via which you
can represent any color of the rainbow
using some combination of red and green
and blue and if any of you are
artistically inclined or have used
Photoshop or similar programs you might
typically have some means of selecting a
color by some grid like this but down
here notice there's explicit mentions of
the types of color systems in use R GB
and in fact here you see 0000 0 and up
here under new you see the color black
and that implies that if you have no red
no green no blue well that indeed would
represent by convention the color black
by contrast if we play around with
Photoshop or similar program if you have
a lot of red a lot of green and a lot of
blue for instance 255 255 255 like
really crank it up to the max value you
can represent with eight bits per week
zero well then it turns out you get the
color white here and we can play with
these numbers endlessly for instance if
we use 255 of red but zero green and
zero blue not surprisingly the square at
the top of the screen Becomes Of course
red entirely because it's all red and no
green no blue if we change it instead to
255 for green but zero for red and blue
of course we get green and then lastly
if we crank up the blue but leave red
and green as zero we of course get blue
but all this while down here highlighted
is something that maybe some of you have
seen before like some combination of
numbers and letters if any of you have
made personal web pages or use programs
like Photoshop you might have used these
so-called color codes so indeed the
world has this convention whereby using
six digits or sometimes three you can
represent a little more succinctly some
amount of red green blue and you'll see
here maybe by inference that if RGB is0
0 255 respectively perhaps where we're
going with this is that
0000 FF is just an alternative way of
expressing the exact same idea no red no
green and a lot of blue but why is that
and in fact we'll come full circle here
to introducing something that we could
have done in week zero but it doesn't
really solve a problem then but today as
we focus more on images and on memory
itself turns out understanding these
patterns is pretty useful so back in
week zero we talked of course about
binary and binary by implying two only
gives you two digits zero and one you
and I as humans almost always use the
decimal system in normal conversation
deck meaning 10 so we have 0 through n
instead if a human like us wants to
count up as high as 10 or 11 or 12 we
don't have a digit per se for 10 11 and
12 we start reusing digits so it's 1 0 1
1 1 2 and so forth but in other systems
not binary not decimal but systems
called heximal hex implying 16 there are
actually more digits than these which
might come as a surprise um it's not
pairs of digits like in decimal single
digits and frankly it doesn't really
matter what the digits are because at
the end of the day these are just
symbols that you and I immediately
associate with some notion of math but
just Strokes on the screen that
represent some have represent some
actual value so it turns out that by
convention
when you want more than n 10 digits 0
through 9 you start using letters of the
English alphabet A B C D E and F and you
can represent them in lower case it's
case insensitive so it doesn't really
matter you might see it in upper case or
lower case but this is how you can count
Beyond N9 not using decimal but using
indeed something called hexadecimal if
we get really technical this is also
known as base 16 and it's the same idea
as week zero where instead of using base
2 for binary base 10 for decimal use 16
as the base for heximal and so if we run
through just some simple examples here
in the world of heximal your columns are
just powers of 16 16 to the 0er 16 to
the 1 16 to the 2 and so forth but in
the world of hex we usually at least
thus far and today we'll see just pairs
of digits like this so here for instance
is the ones column and the 16's column
if we multiply that out so if you wanted
to represent the number you and I know
in in uh the real world as zero in
heximal it would just be 0 0 if you want
to represent the number one it would be
01 and from there we get 02 03 04 0 five
06 07 08 09 now things get potentially
interesting in decimal it would
obviously become 10 but in heximal it
just becomes 0 a and then 0 B which is
to say if I rewind after nine comes in
heximal if I pronounce it in in decimal
this is how you'd represent 10 this is
how you'd represent 11 12 13 14 and then
lastly in heximal the 16th value is f
which is just always going to represent
15 so where to how do we connect this to
some of the past math well once you get
to Zer F in heximal if f is the highest
you can count just like in decimal nine
is the highest you can count what comes
next if this is 15 I claim how do I
represent 16 in heximal with what
pattern of
symbols what pattern of symbols for
heximal yeah so one Z not 10 even though
you might read it like that as a typical
human but one zero because why well even
if this is completely new to you the
whole column system the places are
exactly the same intuitively so you need
a one in the 16's place and a zero in
the ones place and we won't count all
the way up to 255 but we count if we
count a little higher this would be 1 Z
AKA 16 in decimal this would be 1 one
AKA 17 in decimal and then 18 19 20 and
so forth dot dot dot and we can count
all the way up to FF CU if f is the
biggest digit in hexadecimal FF is
indeed as high as we can count and if
each F represents 15 well let's just do
the math like in week zero so 16 * F + 1
* f is how all of us learned to do uh
math in grade school even though not in
heximal that's of course 16 * 15 + 1 *
15 multiply that out you get 240 plus 15
and air go you can count as high as
255 using two heximal digits now this is
not the kind of thing where like this is
going to be an interesting exercise
mentally to ever convert in your head
generally you'll get used to the fact
that after nine comes a and the biggest
digit is f and you'll just start to see
patterns like this in the worlds of
Photoshop web pages in a few weeks and
Beyond but like why is heximal useful
like why are we complicating the world
and adding on top of decimal something
else well it turns out that a single
decimal digit like f the biggest one for
instance is 15 and here let me just
propose a bit of Mental Math how many
bits do you need to represent the number
15 in binary if you've got the ones
place two's Place fours and so forth how
many bits
total so fewer than five to count this
highest 15 I think but
close someone
else sing in hand yeah so four bits I
think suffice because if you want to
count as high as F that is to say 15 I
think if you have four bits you can do
that because if over here is the one's
place from week zero for binary this is
the two's place this is The Four's place
this is the e place do out some quick
math so 8 + 4 is 12 + 2 is 14 + 1 is 15
so it turns out that by convenience
heximal digits can just be represented
consistently with four bits or fewer but
four and four of course is half of eight
and eight is like everywhere like eight
bits is a bite which is again just a
convention we've seen and so the reason
that you see hexad desmal in the world
of Photoshop and eventually web pages is
it actually just Maps really nicely to
expressing binary numbers more
succinctly with a fixed number of digits
so for instance anytime you see 11 one
one one 1111 in the world as binary you
know what that's a little tedious to
both say and write you can represent
more succinctly
any uh group of four one bits more
succinctly in heximal as just F so 111
1111 in binary more succinctly and more
commonly now in the world of Photoshop
memory images and the like is
represented more succinctly as FF and
that's why because it just Maps really
nicely to four bits and so we can be a
little more succinct so any questions on
heximal which is just another way of
representing information but using the
same grade school approach yeah good
question if you represent 15 with f it
would use four bits so base systems are
really just a way for us humans on paper
or on screens to represent information
if F represents the decimal number 15
the computer underneath the hood has to
use four bits to represent it so one
heximal digit by convention always
implies four bits underneath the hood so
therefore if you have two heximal digits
like 0 0 that means eight zero bits
underneath the hood like for red or for
green if you see FF now we know that's
four one bits and another four one Bits
And if we do out the math that's 255
that's why in Photoshop
000000 FF means no red no green and
255 of blue and it's just way more
succinct than writing out like what 8
plus 8 plus 8 24 zeros and ones and it's
just cleaner than even using decimal
when you're using units of eight which
again computers just use everywhere so
it's just another system it's not one
you need to dwell on very much but again
it's fundamentally no different from
binary or decimal we're just using a
slightly different base no all right
well we had this blank canvas here and I
think uh are you two perhaps ready to
reveal for the world what you've created
do you want to go ahead and I'll I'll
swivel it around for you all right here
we go big reveal and today's pixel
art a round of applause if we
could very nicely done well thank you
both if you want to come up after and
tear this off and bring it home you're
welcome to and keep the Post-it notes
too well thank you to our volunteers
there let's now translate this to really
more technical worlds where we're going
to see and consider it more often
because in fact sometimes when you've
had error messages over the past few
weeks from clang the compiler you might
have even seen evidence of heximal we
didn't call it out it wasn't useful to
know at the time but it turns out a lot
of programs use and a lot of code uses
heximal for those reasons of more prec
more representation so for instance
where else might we see it well here's
that picture we keep pulling up of our
computer's memory and each of these
squares in this grid represents a bite
sort of top left to bottom right in the
computer's memory but again just an
artist's representation a few weeks ago
I claimed that each of these bytes can
be numbered of course like this is bite
zero at top left then bite one then bite
two then bite two billion if you have
two gigabytes of memory and so we could
just number them like this 0 through 15
on up 16 17 18 and so forth but per the
reasons earlier it's just more common in
computer systems and in software to
actually use hexadecimal just to
describe the locations of the addresses
of things in memory so instead a typical
programmer or computer scientist would
call these first 16 bytes 0 through F
just because but that's because it's a
predictable number of bits so if we keep
going beyond that you would get not 10
not 11 not 12 but in heximal 1 0 1 1 1 2
and so forth all the way down on the
screen to 1 F and if I you know shrunk
this down or had a bigger monitor we
would see eventually 255 bytes later
from the start 255 as well but there's a
potential problem here with using
heximal in this way there's an
ambiguity can anyone imagine like what
can go wrong if we use hex to just
simply describe locations in memory like
this
yeah yeah yeah like one zero might also
be 10 and you know maybe if you're you
know really thorough okay wait a minute
it can't be 10 cuz here's F over here so
it's obviously not decimal but why
create potential confusion especially
when you're collaborating building
something with someone we want to avoid
that ambiguity and so the convention
humans decided on years ago is that if
you want to make clear that a number is
in hexadecimal just by convention you
prefix all of the digits with Zer X the
X is not like another character it's not
like a 17th character it's just a human
conven
of putting 0x to imply here comes
heximal and now it's unambiguous so now
we see 0x10 obviously is not 10 as we
know it in decimal but rather it's the
number that comes after a single F so
it's really the number in decimal 16 so
0x anytime you see it that's just a
visual cue that what is ahead is
actually heximal so let's now start
playing around with this information so
here's a super simple line of code from
like week one where I'm just declaring
ing a variable n and I'm defining it to
be the value 50 and this is out of
context we probably need a main function
and all of that but let's just rewind to
week one where we actually saw code like
this and do something useful with a line
of code like this so let me go over here
to VSS code and in vs code I'll create a
program called how about addresses since
the goal of this uh the goal here is to
just play around ultimately with a
variable like n and let me go ahead and
do this I'll include how about standard
i.h I'll do int main void so no command
line Arguments for now in N gets 50 and
now so that we can do something mildly
useful with it let's just go use print F
and print out with percent I and then a
new line whatever that value of n is so
this is not going to be interesting per
se it's just week one stuff where I'm
defining a variable and printing it out
to the screen so let me go down to my
terminal window and do make
addresses no errors so that's good I'll
do do/ addresses and of course I should
see the number 50 here now what's going
on underneath the hood let's translate
now code to really what's going on under
under underneath the hood of the
computer so if this is our grid of
memory I don't necessarily know as the
programmer and I definitely don't care
as the programmer where exactly it's
ending up in memory that's the whole
point of using Code let the computer
figure this out but at least
conceptually I know that by declaring a
line of code like that the number 50
ends up somewhere in the computer's
memory and it's assigned the name n a
symbol n via which I the programmer can
refer to it and I very deliberately used
four of these squares for what
reason what might be the reason for
using four squares specifically yeah
yeah so an integer is four bytes at
least most of the time on Modern systems
an integer is four bytes on an older
computer it might just use one or maybe
even uh two bytes But Here by convention
we're almost always going to see four
bytes I don't know if it's going to end
up here it might end up over here but
for now who cares I just know that the
computer can store the the information
in this way underneath the hood so let's
now introduce another feature of C that
we haven't had occasion to use just yet
that's going to allow us to start poking
around the computer's memory For Better
or For Worse and this is one of those
situations where you're about to learn
acquire a a skill a power that can
actually come back to bite you because
once you know how to start poking around
a computer's memory you can do very
powerful things and next week we'll see
what you can build in a computer's
memory but you can also screw up pretty
easily and cause more of those
segmentation faults that a few of you
have already suffered so with that said
let's just stipulate that you know what
I don't care necessarily where the 50 is
in memory but I know it exists at some
address in memory and just so I have an
easy address to pronounce let's just
suppose it lives at ox123 so that's the
address in memory in heximal by
convention and that just happens to be
where it ends up when I write that line
of code but it turns out C has some
other operators we can use when we've
seen the asterisk before the star and
we've used it for multiplication but
today we're going to use it for
something more powerful and we're also
going to introduce an Amper sand which
allows us to do something as well the
Amper sand operator is going to allow us
to get the address of a piece of data in
memory like by literally putting
Ampersand before the name of a variable
C will tell us tell you what address
that variable lives at maybe it's ox123
maybe it's Ox 456 who knows but that
will give you back the answer the Star
does the opposite it's sort of means go
there so using the star otherwise known
as the D reference operator I can
actually go to a specific address if I
want and we'll see what this means in
code so how can I leverage this in some
mildly interesting way to start poking
around but eventually we'll use this
primitive to build more interesting
things so let me go back to save vs code
here and let me go ahead and do this
I'll clear my terminal to start fresh
and I'll introduce another format code
for printf percent p and for now just
take on faith that this it is percent P
because but percent p is going to allow
me to print the address of a variable if
I additionally tell C get the address of
n so I'm changing percent I to percent p
and that's just something you have to do
when printing addresses for now but I
need to change an ampersand in front of
the variable name so I don't print in
the number 50 I print out something like
ox123 and it's not going to be as simple
as that we'll see on the screen though
where it actually ended up in my code
spaces memory so here we go uh dot uh
down in my terminal make addresses again
to recompile and now dot SL addresses
should reveal not the value of 50 but
the address of 50 and there it is it's
pretty long it's not quite as simple and
pretty as ox123 but there's the ox
meaning here's a hexadecimal address and
it's 7f FC c784 a04 C suffice it to say
your codes space and even your Macs and
PCs nowadays have a lot of memory that's
why in part this address is so big not
as small as the thing on my slide so
this at the moment isn't that useful yet
but it introduces us to a concept that
we'll Now call pointers and pointers are
admittedly one of the more challenging
aspects of c and if in future life you
tell friends that oh I took a class
called cs50 and we learned C like you'll
probably get kind of a look at people
like why did you learn C or like oh c
was hard and it's largely because of
this topic which isn't to say that it's
that hard to wrap your mind around but
it's definitely very different and it's
not a feature that you can harness in
higher level languages that we'll see in
class two like Python and Java and the
like C is about as close to the
computer's Hardware so to speak that you
can get before things get actually scary
the so-called Assembly Language we saw
in week two when I had a link and
compile and assemble and all of that
like that gets really lowlevel and you
really have to be an expert with the
computer's CPU or brain to understand
that but with C you can actually poke
around the computer's memory and do
powerful things with that but again with
great power comes responsibility it's
very easy to break programs by misusing
memory or just having a bug that touches
memory in some way that you don't intend
so pointers at the end of the day are
pretty much what we just saw a pointer
is really just a variable that contains
the address of some value a pointer is a
variable that contains the address of
some value or more simply it's fine to
think of it as an address a pointer is
an address of something in the
computer's memory now what might we do
to uh to uh actualize this well here's
two lines of code it turns out by using
our two new operators today I can
declare an INT call it n and assign it a
value like 50 just like before if I want
to store the address of n in a variable
and not just print it immediately via
printf I can declare a variable for
instance called P but I could call it
anything I want like any variable but
because it's an address it's not int P
it has to be int star P so to speak and
the star here on the left hand side of
the equal sign is just a clue to C that
means p is going to be a pointer that is
p is going to be the address of what the
address of an integer now technically
it's still an integer itself right
because an address is just a number
whether it's 1 2 3 or ox123 so this is
really just a semantic difference so in
Star p just means that this variable
doesn't contain any old number like 50
it specifically contains a number that
is the address of something
else so how can I now use this well let
me go back to VSS code and let me
propose that we add a line of code like
that so instead of just directly
printing out that value let's go ahead
and Define a second variable called uh P
that's of type in Star P set it equal to
Ampersand n and then this time let's not
just print out Amper sand n let's
actually print out the value of P so the
only two new things here if I zoom in
are I've used not only the Amper sand on
the right to get the address of n I'm
now using the star on the Left To Tell C
that P is still a still a variable as
always but it's a pointer it is the
address of some other value like this
and I'm still going to print it with the
same format code percent P so that
doesn't change so let me go ahead and
zoom out and do make addresses and slash
addresses and there it is exactly the
same thing now in and of itself not that
useful yet but the fact that you can now
access the addresses of things in memory
means that we'll be able to build things
and construct things and Link things
together by knowing where they live so
to speak so any questions on this
technique thus far
[Music]
yeah a good question on line six must it
be starp and Ampersand and in this case
yes because what am I doing on the left
and I'll get rid of the equal sign for
now this would give me a variable called
P that's not an integer per se but
that's the address of an integer but
without the equal sign I'm not storing
anything in that variable so by adding
the equal sign and then Ampersand N I am
explicitly figuring out with Ampersand
what the address of n is which already
exists per line five and tucking it away
in this new variable called
P other questions yeah every time you
run good question every time I run the
program it uses up a different piece of
memory short answer yes computers though
long story short also have something
called virtual memory so if you run it
again and again you might actually see
the same addresses on the same Mac or PC
or cloud-based server but we'll see in a
bit where uh at a high level it's laid
out but it will always exist at some
address good question yeah some correct
Ampersand n is the address of N and in
Star p
is a pointer called p and honestly in an
Ideal World if C were made today and not
decades ago when humans were first
creating languages you know ideally we
would just have a data type called
pointer and then this would be a little
less complicated because it would
literally be what it says you know the
humans who invented SE didn't do this
but this is the idea so pointer is not a
legitimate word in the code it is a term
of Art in English but this is really
just the idea but the way you express
pointer as a data type type is a little
more cryptic as int star P here but
notice in line seven when I print out p
i don't use a star I don't use an
ampersand y I literally just want to
print the value of p and we've been
doing that since week one if you want to
print a variable just describe the
variable by its name no special syntax
any other questions on this thus
far uh what's the advantage of using
pointers with pointers we'll see today
some applications of them really the
idea is going to come to fruition next
week when we're going to create what are
called uh data structures in memory
where we can build not just uh for
instance uh one-dimensional data
structures like an array we'll see next
week we can actually create the
equivalent of two-dimensional data
structures or even threedimensional data
structures by using these addresses and
sort of linking things together and
we'll see the beginnings of that this
week but for now focus at least for now
on just really the syntax and what these
building blocks can do for us um does
the poin have to be does the p uh in
does the pop pointer have to be an point
to an integer short answer no and we'll
come back to this for now for the sake
of discussion we're only dealing with
integers like the number 50 uh you
mentioned strings or characters
absolutely we're about to go there soon
so you can use the address of anything
you want in the computer's memory so in
fact let's translate this now to just
the same picture just to help you wrap
your minds around what these two lines
of code really fundamentally are doing
so if I come back to my grid of memory
here let's plop the number 50 in the
variable n at the bottom right like it
was before so this is that first line of
code as before but with the new second
line of code as soon as I create P what
do I do well first remember that n lives
somewhere in the computer's memory
usually I don't care precisely where it
is but for the sake of discussion let's
suppose it's at ox123 which is easier to
say than where it actually ended up and
now what is p well p is just another
variable and variables live in memory
too so let me just hypothesize that P
lives up here and it turns out that P
once you assign it the value of
Ampersand N means that c will take a
look at the variable n realize oh it
lives at ox123 and what goes in the
value of p is literally
ox123 so again it's still an integer
which is confusing but it's technically
an integer being used as an address and
now just a a prompt here notice that
this pointer is pretty darn big it's
like eight squares what's the
implication of that because I did that
deliberately
how big must a pointer apparently be in
most modern systems would you say okay
good computers today are very big you
have gigabytes of RAM in your computer
you therefore need big pointers to be
able to point at memory that's
conceptually pretty far away so to be
clear how many bytes does a pointer
apparently take up well it seems to take
up eight in total integers by convention
nowadays are usually four pointers
though nowadays are typically eight in
this case so I'm drawing it in a manner
consistent with the reality even though
at the end of the day it's not really
that interesting what values are in here
in fact let's emerge from these weeds I
don't really care what else is going on
in my computer's memory at the moment
because I've only got those two lines of
Juicy code defining n and defining P so
let's hide all of the other squares and
honestly I mean it when I say that
programmers need to know that a variable
exists somewhere in memory and needs to
be able to get that address using like
the Ampersand but you're never going to
print F like I did the actual address
like it's not generally interesting
unless you're debugging your code but
you're not going to like start typing
out crazy Ox numbers in your code to
move things around you just need to know
that the computer can figure out where
things are so frankly by that logic who
cares that it's ox123 right tomorrow it
could be Ox 456 or something else so one
of the ways to think of a pointer is
literally as a variable that points at
something else and indeed in this case P
yeah technically it has an address and
yeah technically it's ox123 in the story
but honestly who cares I just need to
know that you using p i can get to the
value n and so what are these addresses
and in fact if Carter wouldn't mind
joining me up here for a moment what are
these addresses well just like in our
human world we have mailboxes even
though you might not check it very
frequently nowadays but to get physical
mail every uh home every business has a
unique address the uh science and
engineering complex is 150 Western
Avenue Austin Massachusetts 02134 USA
and theoretically that uniquely
identifies that building in the world
well here we we have two mailboxes um
over here we have a value n that happens
to live I'll claim it address ox123 and
then over here I claim there's another
address uh called by name p i don't
actually care where it is even though it
definitely exists somewhere in the
computer's memory but if this is p which
is a variable and that's n another
variable ideally this mailbox would be
twice as big because of the number of
btes using but Home Depot only had
identical size mailboxes but here is p
one variable there is in another
variable if I open up this mailbox what
should I find inside of it based on our
story thus far like what value will I
pull out dramatically in just a
moment yeah I think ox1 123 Now using
this you can kind of think of this as
like x marks the spot no pun intended
where I can now like walk around the
computer's memory and find my way to
that location by sort of following the
treasure map or if I want it more
dramatically uh thanks to our little
Yale foam finger here here you can think
of it more abstractly as p is just
pointing at n okay that's not going over
well so let's switch over to the Harvard
one so p is
pointing so p is pointing at n and so it
turns out we will be able to write code
now that will do the equivalent of me
walking over to n but for now Carter if
you want to reveal what's in the mailbox
we should see indeed the number 50 so
that's really all that's oh I feel
Carter's waiting for Applause so like
really well nicely done
thank you so that's just like a physical
metaphor of what's going on here in one
variable we have an address and that
variable by convention is called a
pointer in the other variable per week
one we just have a value like n and you
can yes follow the map and walk yourself
to that particular address and we'll see
how to do that in code but what's really
interesting is this abstraction that
pointers literally or really I guess
figuratively point at some other value
in memory all right questions then on
pointers in this form pointers point to
each other can pointers point to each
other so yes there's things called
double pointers we're not going to see
them anytime soon but using star star
you can express an address of an address
um but we won't see that just yet other
questions on
pointers yeah in
front our array so to summarize our
arrays then pointers so short answer
there's a relationship and we'll come
back to that in a little bit but arrays
are technically different from pointers
but we we're going to be able to blur
the lines a little bit by using one like
the other but let me come back to that
in just a bit of time all right so if we
have now this mental model if you will
of like what a pointer is in memory I
think we can start to peel back a layer
of uh simplification that we've been
assuming for the past few weeks since
week one so a string recall is a
sequence of characters and so if you
want to create a string that says Hi in
all caps and an next exclamation point
we do string s equals quote unquote high
and we can hard code it like this or we
could use get string but for now just
assume that I hardcoded it into my code
to always say hi in all caps with an
exclamation point well what does that
look like in the computer's memory well
let's stop looking at the entire memory
let's just focus on really what's going
on once you create a string called s and
store in it hi you know that a couple of
things are happening H and I and the
exclamation point are ending up in the
computer's memory we know from week two
that this thing the so-called null
character n AKA back slz is also being
added for you and it's somewhere in
memory at the moment I don't really care
where I drew it at the bottom right yes
it has an address but for now it just
ends up somewhere and in fact here's a
little visual cue as to how this happens
in C anytime you use double quotes to
give you a string you can imagine that
the double quotes are like a a clue to
not only store Hi exclamation point but
also put the null character there for
you and this is in contrast to what
chars if you want individual characters
what syntax did we use
instead so single quotes single quotes
do not add magically a back SL zero they
literally just store one character so
again strings have always been a little
special you get some extra an extra bite
for free so that you know where the
string ends and functions like stir
compare can then find their way there so
in memory it might indeed look a little
like this and if we assume that there's
going to be somewhere in memory these
things are going to be somewhere in
memory we can address them per week two
by way of the name of the variable so if
s is the name of the variable S braet 0
is how you would refer to the first
letter s bracket 1 s braet two and if
you really want s bracket 3 would get
you at the uh null character at the very
end but what is s so technically in this
line of code here not only is the
computer giving you memory for h i
exclamation point back sl0 we turns out
that s itself must take up some amount
of space right because s is the variable
and every time we' talked about
variables thus far I've given you a
rectangle on the screen in which to
store its value so let's assume for the
sake of discussion that the H is at
ox123 and I is at o x124 exclamation
points at o x125 and the null characters
at ox1 126 well what then is s well s is
just going to be some other variable and
I'll draw it somewhat abstractly without
all the other boxes up here and I'll
claim that the name of this variable is
s but it turns out what is s really how
do strings Really Work Well s is a
variable and has been since week one but
when you define it what the computer is
doing for you automatically is when it
knows you want to store Hi exclamation
point it puts that somewhere in memory
the computer then figures out for you
what's the address of the very first
character and it stores that address and
only that address in the variable you
created on the left hand side of the
equal sign and that's enough like to
represent a string with three letters of
the alph alphabet or punctuation you
don't need three variables you just need
one you just need to know the beginning
of the string why why is it sufficient
for a variable to Only Store the first
byes address and not all of the bytes
addresses exactly because of the design
of strings per week two we always null
terminate them so it suffices to only
remember the first bites address because
from there you can sort of follow the
breadcrumbs bite after bite after bite
and until you see the new line Sorry the
the null character you know that all of
those characters are apparently part of
the same string so this is what's been
going on in the me computer's memory all
since week one and in fact if we
abstract this away you can really think
of s as being just this really a pointer
to that chunk of memory so in fact what
do we have here well in the left to
recap on the code here on the left hand
side string that's what ensures that
we'll actually be able to store a string
in a variable called s we're going to
have on the uh right hand side though
the actual value so let me switch back
to VSS code here and let me change my
code to no longer involve integers alone
so I'm going to add the uh cs50 Library
just so that I can use some shortcuts in
there cs50.h and then in my main
function I'm going to go ahead and do
this string s equals quote unquote high
in all caps exclamation point and then
I'm going to go ahead and print out
using percent S as always back sln the
value of s so this program at the moment
not interesting at all it's just week
one stuff again/ addresses indeed prints
out high but it turns out that now that
I know this what's really been going on
underneath the hood all this time well
here's that same line of code that
defines the variable called s and it
turns out anyone want to guess what
string is actually a synonym
for string it turns out is kind of a
white lie we've been telling since week
one there is no such thing as string as
a keyword in in C it's technically a
cs50 thing
yeah it's a pointer to a character so
really all this time we've kind of been
lying to you there is no string quote
unquote it's actually Char star and if I
may it dramatically here go the training
wheels like okay that didn't land very
well so uh what have we been doing well
it turns out that string is a much
easier way conceptually to think about
what a string of characters is like my
God if we had to start in week one by
having you type char
like yeah you might get past it but like
this is just way too much ugly syntax
not intellectually interesting at all so
we abstract it away what a Char star was
in the first week of C by telling you
it's actually called string now string
is a term of art like C programmers
programmers are in any language we'll
use the word string to mean a sequence
of characters but in C it's not
technically a word unto itself it's
rather a synonym that we ourselves
created in some form so in fact how did
we do this well think back to just last
week last week I proposed that it'd be
really nice if we had a person data type
which the creators of C did not think of
decades ago but that's okay we can
Define it ourselves what did we do here
well using syntax like this recall that
we defined a person to be what to be
this structure this structure using the
new keyword last week struct means that
a person is just a name and a number and
it could have been other things we just
kept it simple but how did I associate
person with that structure well we
claimed that it was this value here type
def which as you might expect defines a
data type so what did we do as cs50 back
in week one without telling you well we
could have done something like this like
int itself is a little cryptic and maybe
we should have to keep things even
simpler said hey everyone turns out you
can Define integers in C and if you
wanted to do this well if you want to
create the keyword integer as a data
type you can just typ def it to int so
typed def creates the word on the far
right integer and U creates a synonym
for it in this case called int so what
did we do in week one without telling
you we have a line of code like this in
the cs-50 library that Associates quote
unquote string with more cryptically
charar and this is why in week one
onward anytime you use the cs50 library
you can write the word string as though
it's a real C data type and that's just
because we wanted to have this
abstraction these training wheels on for
the first weeks so we don't have to get
weeds of all this crazy memory stuff we
can sort of talk about strings at a
higher level but that's all they are
strings are the address of the first
character in that sequence of characters
questions now on any of these details
yeah strings
liar good question what about the
strings Library which we have used um
unrelated so it does not define the word
string everything in there actually
relates to char stars and so in fact if
you've used the CS5
uh manual uh which is just our
userfriendly version of the actual
manual pages for the official language C
you'll see throughout that now if you
start poking around or turning off less
comfortable mode you'll actually see
that we've changed any mentions of
charar in the official documentation for
these first weeks to just string to
simplify it but underneath the hood C
does not know the word string per se as
a keyword but it's absolutely a concept
that like every program in the world
knows about and in fact in other
languages in Python for instance there
will actually be a proper string
although it's not going to be called
string it's going to be called stir St
Str for short questions on these strings
here well let me propose there's one
other feature of this syntax that we can
now leverage as follows let me propose
that if we go back to the previous
version of my code here wherein let me
switch back to vs code in just a moment
I'm going to rewind in vs code to the
integer version of my code from before
and most recently it looked looked like
this before when we were using integers
only and not in fact strings at all let
me propose that there's this other
feature of C that we can use that
actually allows us to go to an address
so at the moment let me just rewind and
do make addresses to remind you what
this program do did when it was using
integers alone and there's that address
why because on line seven notice I'm
printing out the value of P which is a
pointer so of course it's going to look
like an address but let me zoom out now
and make one change and instead of
printing out P how can I use today's
second new operator not the Ampersand
but the star to actually go to that
address well what I can actually do on
this line of code is this if I want to
print out the actual integer 50 that's
in that variable or equivalently at that
address I can go to P here and not print
P literally because that's just an
address I can now say star p and star p
means go there more technically
dreference p that is follow the treasure
map to the actual address and do what
Carter did open the mailbox and print
whatever was in the mailbox which recall
was the actual number 50 so let me try
this let me recompile the code so make
addresses okay let me clear my terminal
window do/ addresses this time I
shouldn't see the ox anything I should
see just the number 50 in this case and
here to is kind of a unfortunate design
decision certainly pedagogically I would
say in C if I zoom in on this code star
is unfortunately being used in two
different ways in an Ideal World they
would have used three different symbols
to make this more semantically clear but
this is what we're stuck with so in line
six when you declare a pointer that is a
variable that stores an address you put
the type of variable that you want to
point at then a star just because and
then the name of the variable and on the
right hand side you actually get the
address of whatever using Ampersand but
when you want to go to an address you
want to dreference a pointer you don't
use int again and we've never done that
right once you declare a variable you
never again mention the data type but in
the world of pointers now if you want to
not print out P but go to whatever
address p is storing you use star P here
so a good visual indicator would be when
you declare a pointer that is make it
exist in your program you have to
declare the data type with the star but
when you use a pointer you just use the
star in an Ideal World this would be a
completely different symbol but again
this is what we have questions now on
that syntax
[Music]
yeah uh why can't we just do the Amper
sand here are you saying it was still a
little quiet so strictly speaking we do
not need line six so this is really for
pedagogical sake that I am um defining a
separate variable p and then printing it
out at this point though I'm just kind
of you know going in circles if you will
because more simple would have been what
I would have done in week one which
would be get rid of P alt together get
rid of P here and just print out n right
but today we're just giving you this new
building block these this new syntax via
which you can figure out the address of
something and then reverse the process
later and actually go to it as
well other questions on what we've done
here with these
pointers all right well let's context
switch back to the string now and see
what more we can do with this here in
the case of our strings here let me uh
refine this to zoom out let me delete
the integer related code here let me do
string s equals quote unquote high in
all caps let me go ahead and for the
moment include cs50.h at the top so that
indeed I can use the keyword s or string
rather and let me go ahead now and do
something more than I did last time last
time I did print F of percent s back sln
and then I printed out s and again I'll
recompile this just for clarity make
addresses addresses that just prints out
high so that's again week one stuff but
now that we have this other bit of
syntax we can do some interesting things
too so for instance suppose I want to
print out not s itself but what if I
want to print out the address of s like
at what memory location is s well I can
change my percent s to percent P which
now we know P is for pointer so percent
p means print out the value of a pointer
that is an address and here I can
actually print out s itself but why that
is we'll see in a moment let me do this
here go the training wheels string does
not technically EX exist but it does if
I'm using the cs-50 library but if I get
rid of the cs50 library as I'm
metaphorically doing by taking off the
training wheels I can't use the word
string anymore and in fact let me make
this mistake deliberately as you might
have accidentally in past weeks here is
the error message I get if I forget the
cs50 library use of Undeclared
identifier string did you mean standard
in it's trying to be helpful but it's
not because I didn't mean standard in so
indeed this is confirmation that c does
not know the word string exists at least
as a keyword exists as a concept but not
a keyword so I could fix this by adding
back the cs50 library but that's kind of
a step backwards educationally is
instead of a step forward what could I
do instead to fix this now if the
training wheels are now off
yeah exactly replace string quote
unquote with Char star instead so I'm
going to go ahead and change this to
char technically you can put the literal
star here the asterisk or you can put it
there or you can put it here by
convention is to do what I done from the
beginning put the star next to the name
of the variable as opposed to anywhere
else uh let me go ahead now and or sorry
I meant to add the spaces there you
could do this too but this would be the
most normal convention so now let's do
this make addresses compile is okay now
do slash addresses what should I see
high or something else feel free to just
call it
out so still high you say someone
else memory location a memory location
all right so could be one of the two
options right either I'm going to see
the string or I'm going to see a memory
address though I do in fact see a memory
address and this one's quite different
from the integer one but does anyone now
want to explain why you were correct why
am I seeing the address down here and
not hi it's subtle
yeah exactly because I left my percent P
there which means hey print F show me a
pointer but this is where printf is
smart and has been smart since week zero
humans who invented printf decades ago
uh wrote code that notices that okay
percent s means to treat the following
value not as just an address per se that
gets printed literally but printed as
with the mailbox demo is sort of a
treasure map that leads you to the
address of a character so simply by
changing one character percent P to
percent s and if I now do make addresses
again and slash addresses this now is
identical to week one but hopefully
makes sense because percent s is just a
clue to print f that means go to this
address in s print out every character
there and thereafter until you see what
the null character and then stop
printing anything more and this is why
hi has printed since week one today we
can see the address percent P but this
combination of having access to
addresses and the null Terminator is all
the information printf needs to actually
do something more useful by like
printing the actual
strings any questions now on this
approach to percent s yeah in
back oh so why is it traditionally being
used in this way honestly like the word
string has been around for decades it's
not a keyword you should be able to type
in C unless you're using a library like
cs50 um and so percent s just means
string so even though it doesn't exist
as a keyword percent s connotes string
and humans decades ago like today just
kind of know what that means so they
could have chosen any letter of the
alphabet but s sort of makes the most
sense all right well let's in back other
question good question before let me
zoom in I did not use a star before the
S why well it's subtle here but printf
is was invented years ago to know given
an address like in the variable s printf
knows to go there so if we looked at the
source code that some human wrote years
ago for C we would likely see the actual
uh asterisk that you're referring to
printf is taking on the responsibility
for going to S if you were to do uh star
s here instead an asterisk and then s
that would now be literally a character
because if I say p uh star s that means
go to the address in s and all you're
going to find there is a single
character what printf wants to know is
not what is the character there what is
the address of that character why
because printf needs to walk through the
rest of those characters looking for the
final null character and in fact let me
see with a bit more syntax if we can
highlight this a bit more let me do this
in addition to printing s let's try out
our syntax in another way let me print
out with percent s how about uh not s
here but let's print out some addresses
percent s back sln close quote and then
let's print out how about this the first
character in the string s would be
called s bracket Z but how do I get the
address of the first character in s well
I could technically just use today's new
primitive I can just add an ampon that
always gives me the address of some
value so when I end this thought and
clear my terminal window and run make
addresses still compiles when I run
addresses in just a moment any guesses
as to what I will see line by line this
will print out two
things and you don't have to remember
what the actual number was but at a high
level what will be printed now the same
thing twice why well when I run this
what I'm printing here and let me zoom
in at the bottom I ined see two really
long addresses but they're in fact the
same why well that's because again if s
is the address of a character as implied
Now by either the cs50 word string or
the actual phrase Char star well then s
is just an address by contrast per week
two s bracket 0 is a Char always has
been a Char a specific Char but if you
want the address of that Char you just
add the Ampersand well it turns out that
strings per the definition we keep
emphasizing is just the address of the
first character in a string so of course
if you do this you're going to see the
exact same thing and if I do this a bit
more generally you don't want to copy
paste but this is just for uh
visualization sake let me print out all
the characters so another another
another and let me change this to print
out the address of bracket 1 bracket two
and bracket three so all four characters
Hi exclamation point and the null
character notice I'm using percent P for
all of them so if I now do make
addresses and do/ addresses now notice
and this is kind of cool the first two
are indeed still the same but what's no
noteworthy about the other values on the
screen yeah they're consecutive each of
these is just one bite away even if
you're not good at hex yet and there's a
crazy number of digits here who cares
they're all the same except for the last
ones four four and then 5 six seven and
this confirms what I've been claiming
for weeks is that in an array all of the
characters are back to back to back
contiguous One Bites away so with just
this Ampersand with just this star like
it's actually a pretty cool tool in the
toolkit to have because you can start to
poke around what's actually going on
inside of the computer's memory and in
fact if we do this I can introduce one
other cool trick here if you will let me
propose that we can actually now do
arithmetic on pointers and you don't
have to you'll see a simpler way to do
this but now that you have perhaps this
underlying understanding of where things
are in memory and it's just addresses we
can actually do something kind of neat
we can do something like this uh let me
go back to how about uh the string
version of this with high and let me do
this instead let me um clean this up a
bit get rid of some of these lines of
code and let me do this let me print out
percent C percent C percent C let me get
rid of all these Amper Sands we're going
to roll back to like week two stuff just
to be clear when I compile and run this
version of the program and I'll zoom in
what should get printed on the screen
this is just week two stuff now no
pointers per se yeah
mhm just Hi exclamation point one per
line because I have all of these back
slash ends so let me do that let me go
down here make addresses enter okay
pretty good/ addresses and indeed Hi
exclamation point But now if you're
getting a little more comfortable and
it's fine if you're not yet today but
over the coming week or weeks as you get
a little more comfortable with the
equivalence of addresses with our
definition in the past of arrays and
strings and all of this you can start to
play around and I can do this instead if
I I want to print out the first
character in the string I could do like
week two s bracket zero like that will
always work and you can keep using that
that's not a cs50 thing it's just a
convenience in C but I could technically
print out not s because s is an address
but what would be the syntax I could use
to say print out the character at
s any
Instinct how can I say go to the address
in
s it's one of two possible answers
today so of our two new uh uh of our two
new operators today we have the
Ampersand and the star which one will
lead us to what is that an address so
the star so in fact if I want to print
out what is that address zero at the
address S I can just do star s and if
you really want to get fancy how do you
print out the second character that's
immediately to the right of it so to
speak well you can go to with the D
reference operator and do you want to
answer this
one s+ one Argo pointer arithmetic like
you can do math simple addition
subtraction whatever on pointers if you
want and you can do this here too so
star you want to pluck this one off too
how do I print out the last character
the
third s plus2 right because if you know
and understand that like a string is
just a sequence of characters every
character is just a bite and these bites
are back to back to back you can just go
wherever you want in the computer's
memory and here I can do make addresses
again/ addresses and voila we now have
high exclamation point so we haven't
printed out anything new but again just
by using these two new operators the
erson and the star you can figure out
the address of something and you can go
to the address of something okay
question in
back indeed it ends up being the exact
same and so I might have used this term
before the Amper sand technique where
sorry the square bracket technique where
you do s bracket 0o s bracket One S
bracket 2 that's actually what we would
really call syntactic Sugar like it
works and you can use it you should use
it it's nice and simple
but the square bracket notation
underneath the hood is essentially being
converted to this which this is not fun
right like this is when you want to show
off to your friends like you know how to
do cool stuff in code but this is not as
readable as just s bracket Z and one and
two but that's all that's happening
underneath the hood and so again this is
why in cs50 we spend time on some of
these lower level building blocks
because if you assume that indeed your
computer's memory is just this grid of
btes and you have now the code ability
in code to get an address and go to an
address you can start doing any anything
you want and you can poke around a
computer's memory at any location and
here in lies the danger like I'm kind of
on the honor System right now that if my
string is high exclamation point it's
kind of up to me to go to the first bite
the second and the third but I could get
kind of crazy now and if I want to see
what's going on in the computer's memory
I mean there's nothing stopping me from
doing like s+ 50 and let's see what's
there so make addresses do/ addresses Hi
and then okay nothing it seems well how
about 5,000 bytes away let's poke around
what's inside of the computer's memory
so make addresses again uh make
addresses addresses enter okay still
nothing there let's try
50,000 all right do make addresses do SL
addresses okay there we see it so you've
probably done this some of you by
accident because you probably went too
far to the left or to the right in an
array touching memory that you shouldn't
suffice it to say I should not go
blindly touching 50,000 bytes away cuz
who knows what's there and indeed in
your computer computer when a program is
running the computer uh segments it into
different segments of memory and if you
get a little too greedy and you touch
another segment of memory that
technically was not allocated to you by
Mac OS or Windows or Linux or the
operating system bad things happen and
you get a segmentation fault and that
means it's a bug in your code so you can
now do this and this means hackers too
can do things like this if they can
somehow inject code into your C program
maybe they can poke around the
computer's memory and indeed this is
kind of the technique whereby maybe a
really sophisticated hacker can jump to
this memory this memory this memory
looking for something like your password
or your financial information or
anything that's in the program but at
some other address there's nothing
stopping an adversary at least right now
from poking around if they can execute
code on your computer from doing this
kind of thing so there and again is the
power of C but also the danger and
you'll absolutely suffer more segals in
the coming days but ultimately the goal
is going to be to help you solve them
ultimately uh and fix things um but for
now I think that was that was quite a
bit so let me propose that we go ahead
and take our longer break here maybe 10
minutes and have ourselves some whoopy
pies in the transcept we'll be back in
10 all right so we're back and to recap
where we left off you now have this new
capability in code to do pointer
arithmetic like treat addresses as
numbers which they really are in heximal
or otherwise and like add them together
and kind of poke around a computer's
memory and it was asked during break
actually how we might further harness
this in the context of string so I
didn't change the code we wrote just
before break recall that we last broke
the program by checking out bytes 50,000
bytes away but let's not do that and
let's actually try printing out not
individual characters like I did per the
percent C but why don't we try printing
out strings and substrings if you will
so let me clear my terminal window let
me change all of these percent C's to
percent s percent s percent s and then
let me rewind to what we've been doing
since week one with strings which is
just print them out for instance with
that first line and the only difference
at the moment is that now I took off the
training wheels I got rid of cs50.h
wherein string is typ Def to char star
for you got rid of that so now on line
five I'm declaring S as being a Char
star which just means the address of a
character and print f is smart enough to
know that the end of a string is
wherever that null character is but now
that I can do pointer arithmetic notice
that I could do something like this if I
want to print out s i just print out s
suppose I do s+ one here and s+2 here
again after changing percent C to
percent s any intuition around what this
code will now print on the screen line
by
line yeah
thoughts okay reasonable conjecture
maybe the memory address of H that of I
that of exclamation point but other
[Music]
thoughts yeah I think it's going to do
the latter it's going to print high in
the usual way because honestly line five
is this rather line six is the same as
like week one stuff except we took off
the training wheel of string and we're
calling it Char star but I think line
seven is indeed going to print out I and
line eight is just going to print out
because it'll be just the exclamation
point prti will still be smart enough to
know where each of those substrings a
portions of the string End by the same
logic as always but let me go ahead and
zoom out run make addresses enter
compiles okay/ addresses and now indeed
this is all a string is it's a sequence
of characters identified by its first
bite if you then start poking around and
tell printf to print at what's at the
next bite or the next next bite it's
going to do its same thing printing out
that character and everything after it
up until that null character so again
even though there's like a lot going on
we've introduced these two new operators
like there's nothing that's happening
today that hasn't been happening for
weeks but hopefully through this week uh
this week's lecture this week's problem
set and Beyond you'll start to realize
that now you just have more tools via
which to harness those lower level
implementation details so last week too
recall one other implementation detail I
claimed that you could not compare two
strings quite as easily as you could
compare to uh integers for instance and
I told you to use a different function
instead that you probably used one or
more times with the past problem set how
are you supposed to compare strings
apparently yeah so string compare stir
comp that additional function that we
said H you just have to use it for now
but you might have a little intuition
already as to like why we have to use
Stir compare and we can't just use
equals equals to compare strings like
any intuition for this already why was
Stir compare necessary last week
equ perfect equals equals would compare
literally the two memory addresses
instead of the actual strings character
by character and unless the memory
addresses are literally the same so you
compare the that exact same memory
address two different strings probably
are not going to be considered equal
even if to us humans they indeed look
equal so let's see this let me go ahead
and close addresses. C and actually
before I do one last mention one of the
powerful things about Pointer arithmetic
as an aside is that c and really the
compiler is smart enough to know how
many bytes to keep adding and adding and
by that I mean this right now we got
lucky because a string is a sequence of
characters and by definition every
character is is a single bite you can
poke around and do s+ one to get the
next bite S Plus 2 to get the uh the
third bite however if we weren't dealing
with strings suppose we were dealing
with integers that were in an array back
to back to back if you wanted to get at
the next integer you could still do plus
one or plus two to get at the next or
the next next integer you would not
start to get into the weeds of doing
plus four and then plus eight you don't
have to know or care how big the data
types are in the computer C and the
compiler will figure that out for you
based on the data type in question so
keep that in mind if ever doing this on
a different data type uh than chars all
right so let me go ahead and open up a
file that I wrote in advance most of and
let me hide my terminal window and show
you this so here is a program called
compare. C whose purpose in life is to
compare two strings I'm back to using
the cs50 library because at least for
now in probably a couple more weeks it
is so much easier to get input from the
user using cs50's function get in but
we'll conclude today by taking off those
training wheels as well so you can see
how you can actually get user input with
nothing cs50 specific so line six and
seven pretty boring week one stuff get
an INT called I get an INT called J and
store them in two variables I and J
respectively if I equals equals J print
out the same else print out that they're
different let me just stipulate for time
sake I'm pretty sure this code is
correct this will get two integers from
the human it will compare them and tell
me correctly if they're the same or
different and I'll prove as much by
running make compare
slash compare and I'll type in 50 for I
50 for J and they're the same and now
I'll do how about 50 and say 13 and
those are different so let me just
stipulate this code is indeed correct
would have worked in week one also works
now in week four but let me now change
it to compare not two integers but as I
hinted maybe two strings instead so let
me go ahead and change this line of code
to maybe be string s equals get string
uh asking the user for s s uh then let's
change this second line here to be
string T just to keep the variable name
short for now and T is a good uh Choice
after s for something like this get
string prompt the human for T and then
let's change our I and J here to do the
wrong thing per the intuition earlier if
s equals equals T then print out the
same else print out that they're
different now if I want I could take off
at least some of the training wheels I
could change this to char star I could
change this to char star either is fine
I still need the Cs library though
because I'm using get string because
it's actually hard as we'll see today to
get strings manually without using a
library but I'll keep it using string
just for now with the library all right
make compare
again compare and now let me go ahead
and type in for instance Hi exclamation
point Enter and Hi exclamation point
Enter and they're different all they're
obviously not visually but they are
underneath the hood and you probably do
have the intuition for this already
whereby what's going on underneath the
hood is that we're comparing
accidentally the two memory addresses so
in fact let's go there let's consider
the memory and let me zoom out now so I
can just have more btes to play with so
the squares are a little smaller than
before just so we can fit more in them
and let me propose that when I declare s
on what was line six a moment ago it
ends up somewhere in memory like the top
leftand corner of my picture for
discussion sake and when I uh execute
that same line of code and get string is
called and I type in high exclamation
point we know from week one that get
string puts it somewhere in the
computer's memory and I'll propose that
it's in like the bottom left hand corner
of the screen here what happens after
that well I know even though I don't
generally care that Hi exclamation point
in the null character exist at some
address like ox123 12 4 125 126 for
discussion sake and what's in s same as
before break 0x1 23 so that's all that's
happening again on line six which is
pretty much the same as when we were
getting an S earlier but notice now with
line seven when I get a second variable
called T and I call get string again and
by coincidence as the human I type the
same thing well what happens here T gets
its own chunk of memory maybe at the top
right uh that second version of high
gets somewhere else in memory you know
the computer could be smart and notice
it's the same but C doesn't generally do
that for you it just plops it somewhere
else in memory and maybe it's at address
Ox 456 457 458 459 or wherever but you
can perhaps see where this is going
already T now of course contains the
address of that first bite and so in my
code on line nine when I compare s and t
for equality suffice it to say they are
not equal because of the way the uh
strings are laid out in the computer's
memory it's indeed looks the same the
same values are there but if we abstract
away further you can really see that s
and t are not the same themselves and so
how did we fix this or really how did we
avoid this last week without spilling
the beans and going down this Rabbit
Hole explaining like why you have to use
Stir compare well if I go back to my
code here let's do it now the right way
let me go ahead and include uh a line of
code that says string compare of s comma
T both as inputs and then if you recall
what does stir compare return when two
strings are equal there's three possible
return values so zero so one is for if
it comes alphabetically or atically
first or second but for now I just want
zero if I want to use S compare I do
need
string.h so string.h does exist that's
not a cs50 thing there's no keyword
string as a data type that's a cs50
thing but string.h does exist so I think
now with that change on line 10 if I do
make compare and slash compare and then
run again uh type again High exclamation
point High exclamation point I think now
they're the same and just as a uh second
check high in L caps maybe high in
lowercase those are in fact different
why well stir compare which was written
by some other human decades ago is just
smart enough to know that it should go
to S and go to T start comparing them
left to right stopping once it hits one
or both null characters and return zero
only if everything in s and and T are
exactly the same are any questions then
on this
here any questions on why we're using
stir compare all right if no yeah oh in
the
middle yes so so why does why is it not
the case with integers so it turns out
it's not the case with integers with
floats with bulls with uh doubles with
Longs like literally every other data
type works correctly strings though are
special they are useful enough in
programming and have been for decades
that the authors of printf and the
authors of stir compare and bunches of
other functions Sterling for that matter
just kind of treat strings special
because they're just useful right we
humans interact using language be it
English or anything else and so it's
just useful to have into the language C
just sort of uh first class support for
this notion of strings of human text so
the short answer is just because like it
just uh is necessar strings are
different they're implemented with this
address and the null character
everything else though is just a value
but a string again is a white lie it's
an address it's not a thing unto itself
good question yeah in front
oh really good question so in my code
here in vs code what if I do this
instead of stir compare and instead of
if s equals equals T what if I start
playing around using star s and star T
really interesting case to consider
let's go back to our sort of deductive
logic here so star the asteris operator
today means go there so when I've typed
in high once and then high again both
uppercase for instance what is at the
address s literally someone
else what is at the address s yeah uh so
not quite at the address not so not what
is the address what is at the address
ox123 H and what is at the address Ox
456 H also and so here you're kind of
cheating like you're comparing the first
character of both strings but not every
other one now you could be really
pedantic and here again this is like a
good use of uh codee but you could do
this if that and how about this
craziness so star
s+1 equals equals star t + one and and
you could do this for every character
manually but that's why stir compare
exists it does all of this for you but
that's why and that's the intuition so I
would encourage you too anytime there's
something kind of weird going on there's
I realize we might be um straining
credibility now we haven't told you that
many white lies and so most everything
that we've seen thus far can explain
pretty much all of the behavior up until
now from week one onward in C so let me
revert this back to the right way if s
compare of S&T equals equals z this now
is the right version of the code and now
here is again where you can play so let
me do this let me um clear my terminal
window just to tidy things up let me get
rid of all of this comparison stuff and
let's just see what's going on as you
are welcome to in your own code let's
print out for instance as we might have
in week one the value of s itself in a
new line comma s and then let's just
print out T just to make sure it
compiles and I'm not doing anything
wrong but this is not going to be that
interesting and frankly I don't need
string.h anymore because I'm not using
stir compare so make addresses addresses
there's my um oh sorry that's fun okay
not percent T percent s here too ignore
that let's do this again make a oh and
that's the wrong program okay dot SL
let's do make
compare compare and let's type in high
again and high again and and now we just
see the two strings I'm not comparing
but now we can kind of play around right
instead of printing out percent s which
prints the string how do I print the
address in S I just need to make a
slight change if I want to see not
what's at s but I want to see s the
address
yeah perfect so change percent s in both
places here to percent P so now printf
will treat it literally as an dress it's
not going to do any fanciness this with
a loop from left to right looking for
the null character it's just going to
print out S&T so let me clear my
terminal run make compare whoops let's
do make comparecompare enter type in
high type in high again and now you see
oh so this is interesting it's not quite
as straightforward as the other values
which were slight one bite away they're
almost the same but this one ends in b0
this one ends in F0 so they're indeed
separated by some number of bytes not
just one but a few because these strings
are indeed longer all right so once
you've seen this here how can we now
maybe leverage this to solve other
problems well let me propose that we do
this let me uh zoom out here let me
close compare and let me open up another
program I wrote part of in advance
called
copy.c so copy. C in theory makes a copy
of a string how on line eight I'm using
the same thing as before get string
storing in a string or char star and
asking the user for it then I'm not
asking get string again I'm just making
a copy super simply with line 10 here
string T equals s now intuitively I
think that's how I would copy a variable
right that's how we've copied variables
every week thus far and see but
something's going to go wrong in line 12
in English does someone want to explain
what you think line 12 does don't worry
about finding any bugs or mistakes but
what does line 12 seem to be doing using
two upper which which is thanks to the
ctype library which I've included the
header file for
yeah yeah right it's kind of like ugly
syntax but this would seem to be
capitalizing the first letter of T
specifically and just changing it so we
have t bracket Zer here because we want
to save the change and we're passing to
two upper the first character here so
this is how we did uppercase in the past
and now I print out s and t respectively
using percent s so this feels like it
should work I copied s and stored it in
t on line 10 and then I change T and
only t on line 12 but you can perhaps if
you're comfy thus far see where this is
going if I do make
copy copy and let me type in lowercase
Hi exclamation point this time just once
so I'm going to hit enter and watch what
we see for the value of s and
t huh the new value of SN T at the end
of my program seems to be what it seems
to be
the same high is capitalized both times
so what's the intuition then for this
why did this just
happen yeah and
back yeah I assigned S&T the same memory
address so it did copy s into T but C
takes this very literally what is s it's
an address what is T it's a copy of that
address if you want to copy the whole
string like a normal human would expect
hey you or someone has to do a lot more
work you have to go to that address copy
this character this one this one this
one and copy it to a new location in
memory that does not happen
automatically here for you in C it does
in some other languages those of you
who've programmed in certain higher
level languages this just works as you
would hope and that's one of the
benefits of python and other languages
that we'll soon see but for now it
literally takes at face value what this
is copy the address into this address
and I'll make that more clear by getting
rid of the string keyword which again is
just a type def this is technically an
address here this is technically an
address here so what's being being
copied is the value of that address not
all of the characters that might very
well follow it so I should make one note
to here I'm going to start getting more
in the habit of trying to avoid
segmentation faults because things could
go wrong here for instance online 12
previously I was kind of blindly naively
dangerously assuming that there will be
at least one character in s or t that
might not be the case if the user Just
Hits enter there's no characters to
uppercase and so this is reckless of me
and could theoretically create a sigall
so I should probably start to be smarter
and say something like this if the
length of T is greater than zero okay
now it's safe to actually capitalize the
first letter and that will decrease the
probability now of those segmentation
faults by just not making any
assumptions about what the human does
almost always the your programs will
crash when you've made a mistake yes but
the user gives you an input that you
yourself did not
expect so what does this all look like
in memory well let's go back to the Big
Grid this time focusing on the copying
of values and let's do this here's S as
in this new program just declared to be
a Char star uh here is where my
lowercase High maybe ended up in the
computer's memory that's probably at
ox123 12 4 125 whatever something like
that and that's of course what ends up
in s as a value when I declare T I do
get a second variable called T just like
before but when I copy s into T what
happens it's really just literally ox1 2
3 whatever the value of s is is now also
the value of T and so if we abstract
this away at a high level get rid of all
of those extra squares this is what s
and t now are they're indeed copies but
copies of each other not copies of the
underlying characters and so if you
follow those arrows um and try to print
them both out after capitalizing one or
the other you're going to unfortunately
end up capitalizing not just one of them
s but both of them s and T because
literally it's the same address any
questions then on this
visualization
yeah good question is this pass by
reference we haven't um we have not seen
in detail an example like that um right
now you're copying by value but
references will come into play and
remind me in a bit if I haven't used
that term yet but this is just copying
things by could have ended poorly value
other
questions no all right so with this in
mind like how do we actually copy things
properly for this we actually need
another building block so today we give
you two functions one of which is called
Malo one of which is called free and
these are used all of the time by like
every piece of software you and I use on
our Macs PCS and phones whether it's
written in C or some equivalent other
language Malo is for memory allocation
it's a function that you can use to ask
the operating system Mac OS Linux
Windows anything for some number of of
bytes one bite 100 bytes a gigabyte of
memory you can ask malog for however
much memory you want in advance it will
return to you the address of the first
bite of memory that it found free for
you unlike a string it is not null
terminated and so the danger with malok
is that it's on the honor System if you
ask it for one bite or 10 bytes you the
programmer in like a variable have to
remember how many byes you requested one
or 10 or the like strings do that for
you not when we're getting now to this
low level Mal just going to give you
some memory and it's up to you to manage
it free does the opposite when you're
done with some chunk of memory you can
free it by passing in that same address
and just hand it back to Mac OS windows
or Linux and say I'm done with this you
can let me use this for something else
later um as an aside if your computer
has ever like frozen or hung like the
whole thing maybe just spontaneously
reboots yet another reason for a bug
like that might be if you write a
program with a bug that keeps Mal
loocking Mal loocking Mal loocking that
is asking for more and more and more
memory but you make a mistake and you
never free it well eventually the
computer is going to literally run out
of memory and something's going to go
wrong and that's often when computers
freeze like they're just out of memory
it has the memory there but the program
was trying to use too much of it
endlessly so this too will be a mistake
that some of us will surely make in the
coming weeks but hopefully you'll now
see the solution so let me go back to uh
vs code here and let me propose that we
do the following I'll hide my terminal
window for a moment and I'm going to
introduce another header file up here
and I promise there's not going to be
too many more of these but this one is
called standard li. for standard library
and in this file are the Declarations
the prototypes for malok and free and a
bunch of other stuff as well it lets me
now manage my own memory so let's focus
now on line 11 line 11 is where I went
wrong before because conceptually I want
to copy the whole string but of course
I'm only copying modestly the individual
address so how do I copy the whole darn
thing well what I need to do is this
when when I declare T to be the address
of something in memory why don't I set T
to be the address of a free chunk of
memory so let me ask the operating
system give me this many bytes tell me
what the address is and I'm going to
store that in t initially just so I know
where there's free space for me so how
do I do that well quite simply I call
malok and then I pass in the number of
bytes that I need now for Hi exclamation
point I think I need three although wait
no I really need four because of the
null character but I don't think I
should be hardcoding numbers like this
cuz who knows what the human's going to
type in so I can actually use Sterling
of s and then plus one this will ask
malok then for however many btes
corresponds to the number of characters
the human typed in plus one for again
the null character so it's just being
smart and defensive rather than choosing
a number myself but now all T is is a
pointer if you will to some random chunk
of free space so there's nothing there
yet or there's you know bits there but
who knows what value they are they're
certainly not identical to what the
human type did in I now have to do this
so how can I copy one string into the
other well let me do this instead of uh
capitalizing something just yet let me
do this how about four in I gets zero I
is less than the length of
s uh and then i++ so I'm going to
iterate for the whole length of the
string and in here I'm just going to do
this the E character in t should be
identical to the E character in s so I'm
just literally copying from right to
left each and every character in s and I
can trust that there's enough memory in
t why cuz I asked for that many bytes
plus one now there's technically a bug
here I actually should probably do this
I should do plus one here or if you
prefer I should do less than or equal to
the Sterling but I think it's a little
clear to do the plus one why do I for
the first time want to go just beyond
the boundary of s and copy one more
bite yeah yeah I need the null character
like I could technically manually add it
with some additional line of code but I
might as well just copy it because back
sl0 is back sl0 so this time and
probably only this time it's reasonable
and correct to go just beyond the
boundary of your string so you copy the
null terminating character so that the
computer also knows where T ends and now
I think what I can do a little more
safely is this let me go down here and
say t braet 0 equals 2 upper of t uh two
upper of T bracket Z so same line of
code as before if I actually want to be
really safe I should probably do this so
if the stir L of T is greater than zero
so there's at least one bite there okay
now it's safe to blindly capitalize the
first character and I think that now
puts me in better shape so let me try
this now let me uh open up my terminal
make uh copy do slash copy I'm going to
type in Hi exclamation point in all
lowercase crossing my fingers this time
and now if I zoom in it indeed
capitalized only T and not s in this
case so pictorially let me switch over
here here is as before the variable s
pointing at high in all lowercase when I
call malok though that gives me a chunk
of memory that I'm going to store the
address in t of so if T is some other
variable as it is in my code and there's
some other available chunk of memory I
don't know where it is but let's assume
as always it's at Ox 456 4557 4558 N9 so
four bytes total what is now happening
well T is defined as pointing to that
because that's what Malo gives us the
address of the first bite of the free
memory and now with my for Loop I'm just
iterating over it copying the H then the
I then the exclamation point and then
for good measure the back slash Zer
instead questions then on this process
here a really good question um if I
omitted in my code the
uh plus one and I didn't do less than or
equal to so that I'm copying the fourth
bite odds are in this program because
it's so short you wouldn't notice that
there's an actual error but what could
happen is When I Call printf On T if
there's no null bite there it might
print h i exclamation point some random
value some random value some random
value some random value until it gets
lucky and there happens to be a zero
bite a null bite by chance for instance
so if you don't include the back sl0
some way that's going to happen and I
say some way I could even do this I
could technically just copy the length
of the string s and at the very bottom
here I could do something like T bracket
I uh sorry T bracket um
Sterling of T I could do this but this
is just not necessary like I could
manually add it at the end of the string
but again i' claim that it's just
simpler to borrow that is copy the one
that's already in s because it's the
same thing at the end of the day good
question other questions on this copying
correctly
[Music]
now all right is there any room for
improvement here well let me propose a
slight optimization this is kind of a
throwback now to week one turns out that
arguably my line 13 here wherein I have
this for Loop now that I'm doing things
in Loops again and again and using a
function like Sterling this is correct
it will iterate from zero on up to the
length of I a length of uh s plus one
but it's kind of stupid of me to write
this for Loop in this way why well
here's my initialization on the left
here's my condition in the middle and in
general calling a function inside of
your condition is probably not very good
design like why why is it bad for me to
be calling a function like Sterling in
this condition in the middle of my for
Loop
yeah yeah you're just calling it again
and again for no reason like the length
of s never changes so like why are you
wasting everyone's Time by calling
Sterling of s again again again again
just to check this inequality whether I
is less than that value so it turns out
if you haven't discovered this already
there's a slight optimization we can do
here that has nothing to do
fundamentally with strings or pointers
just with better design I can actually
Define two variables at once I could do
this let me remove this whole condition
and let me add a comma after I equals 0
set n or any variable equal to the stirl
of s + 1 and then after the semicolon
just ask the question while I is less
than n so it's almost the same but
notice now my condition in the very
middle of this Loop is at least
comparing two static values n never
change sorry one static value n never
changes all that changes is I but I'm
not foolishly calling sterling sterling
sterling again and again why well how
does Sterling work similar in spirit to
PR print F Sterling given the name of a
string looks at the first character and
then starts looking through the entire
string looking for the null character
and we saw this in week two counting up
how many characters are there so it's
just a waste of time again and
[Music]
again totally if you wanted to use n
multiple times you could absolutely take
it out of the for Loop put it right
after s is defined and reuse n and again
and again absolutely but in General
consider this when designing your for
Loops even though modern compilers like
cang can actually fix this problem this
inefficiency for you good practice would
be don't call functions unnecessarily
especially if the answer is always going
to be the same all right so what else
should I perhaps refine here well how
about I do one last thing and just
comment on what exactly could go wrong
here well a couple of things well
actually this is just silly too like
surely someone before me in the world
has had to copy a string before surely
there's a function like called stir copy
maybe like stir compare like stir Ling
and indeed there is so let me propose
that we actually get rid of this whole
for Loop and we actually just call a
function called stir copy no o just St
cpy and pass in the destination which is
T first and then the source that you
want to copy into the destination and
that takes the place entirely of that
whole Loop so again I demonstrated the
loop first just to be very pedantic
about it but that's wasting time you're
wasting time writing lines of code you
don't need to stir copy is what you can
use here instead and so this has now
always existed and what more can I do
well as one final point it turns out
that there's actually things that can go
wrong in this code even besides the
string being too short like if the human
Just Hits enter and there are no
characters I don't want to blindly
capitalize the first character that
doesn't exist that's why I added that if
condition but there's other things that
can go wrong and we introduced those to
you today it turns out that functions
like get string and functions like Malo
return potentially a special value and
wonderfully confusingly it's also called
null but with two L's all right so left
hand and right hand weren't talking so
well like decades ago NL is a back SL
zero it's a single character as it
always has been for a couple of weeks
now
n is technically a pointer it's an
address but it's address zero it's like
the top left hand corner if you will of
your computer's memory that just nothing
is ever supposed to go in by convention
so null is a synonym for zero but it's
specifically an address now why is this
useful well suppose that in my code here
something goes wrong with get string
suppose you're being a little crazy and
you type in way too long of a string
it's not just high but it's like an
entire essay of text and there's not
enough memory in the computer how does
get string signal to the programmer whoa
like that's way too big of a string I
can't fit it in memory well we never
told you this but all of this time it
turns out that that get string will
return this special value called null if
something goes wrong so to be really
careful now you should do something like
this if s equals equals literally null
then you better um exit the program
entirely and return like one or two or
three to signify that something went
wrong don't uh go any further similarly
with malok it's possible if you ask for
way too much memory that could fail
especially if you're asking now for
double the memory after the human typed
something in so if T equals equals null
then you know what but let's also return
one or some other value to just get out
before something crashes or freezes on
the human as well so honestly I tend not
to do this always in class because the
code just gets so bloated and
complicated but you absolutely in
practice need to start doing this
otherwise you will be responsible for
the freezes and the crashes and the
reboots that users in the real world
might actually encounter otherwise of
course if we get to the bottom of this
program now I should probably return
zero explicitly or implicitly to just
signify that everything is is
successful but there's one other thing I
haven't done we introduced malok but
what did I claim also
existed so free I'm also being a little
reckless now here I am not practicing
what I'm preaching I'm asking the
computer for memory via get string I'm
asking the computer for more memory my
via malok and I'm never technically
handing it back so really what I should
be doing at the very bottom of my
program to is freeing the memory I've
asked for so henceforth it is a rule a
law if you will in see whenever you
allocate memory with malok or certain
other functions as well you the
programmer must free it when you're all
done with it now this is a bit of an
overstatement because technically when
programs quit they'll free the memory
automatically so you're not going to
break someone's Mac or PC because you
necessarily have this bug but for
programs that are running all the time
like someone keeps a chrome their
browser open Microsoft Word or the like
bad things will happen if over time you
never never never call free and the
program keeps running so always get into
this habit here you you do not need to
free memory that comes from get string
because the cs50 library automatically
frees it for you but you anytime you use
malok henceforth as you did or I did
here you must free that by just passing
in the same address you got back
questions now on malok and
free questions
yeah oh really good question so free
just so what does free do so free um
just uh lets the computer know that you
are done with that chunk of memory which
means that if you have a another line of
code elsewhere that same memory might be
reused and can be used again and again
and that's going to be necessary
certainly for any long running program
you can't ask for memory constantly
you'll eventually run out so you need to
free it in this way other languages as
an aside python you get another
motivation in a couple of weeks for it
is going to be Python and certain other
languages manage all this headache for
you but in C the goal here is to really
harness these capabilities ourselves all
right so it turns out like almost
everyone in the room everyone in the
room myself included you're going to
screw up when it comes to anything
memory related if you haven't already
segals are in your future but hopefully
there's tools via which you can detect
these things and fix them proactively
and not just use print def uh or debug
50 or rubber duck we actually have
another tool we can equip you with now
that help you find some mistakes so let
me do this let me close copy.c let me
open a program I wrote In Advance called
memory. C that doesn't do anything
really interesting but it's going to
have two bugs in it notice that I've
included standard i.h as always I've
also included standard li. which is
necessary now for anything related to
malok Andor free and the like line six
it's a little weird what I've done here
but this is like the manual way of
asking for enough memory for an array in
week two how do we ask for memory for an
array you very simply say int X3 and
that gives you an array called X of size
three but if you do it manually Now
using Malo what you have to do is use
syntax like this you call malok you ask
for three things times however big an
INT is now we know it's four so you
could literally write 12 here but this
is more generic so three times the size
of an integer will give you 12
dynamically and what do Malo return the
address of the first bite you get back
what do I want to put that well I want
to put it in a variable now the variable
can't just be int X because that's a
number it's not an address per se if I
want to store this address in a variable
I could call it X I could call it P but
in Star X just means that X is now the
address of a chunk of memory
specifically a chunk of memory that's
big enough not for one but for three ins
in total all right now I'm just sort of
naively putting our old friends 72 73
and 33 at the first second and third
locations in memory but perhaps based on
week two or week four I'm clearly
screwing up up here in a couple of ways
someone want to identify at least one
bug what did I do
wrong yeah like this is now you know
amateur uh stuff like I should be zero
indexing not one indexing so this has
got to be 0 one2 ultimately and other
bugs that are maybe more week four
specific other bugs it's more subtle
yeah I'm not freeing the memory right so
I'm not practicing what I'm preaching by
freeing this memory now suppose these
are non obvious and honestly after like
an hour or two of this like this
shouldn't be obvious yet it will be over
time how could I find these bugs with uh
software as opposed to just staring at
the thing or asking someone for help
well let me propose this let me first go
ahead and run make memory to compile the
program and it seems to work look fine
there's no syntax errors at least
dotmemory notice seems to work fine too
now this program doesn't do anything
interesting there's no printf or
anything like that but it didn't crash
there's no segmentation fault but that
doesn't mean there aren't bugs latent in
the software and this is true sadly of
all of today's software like Chrome and
Microsoft Word and other programs surely
have memory related bugs that people at
Google and Microsoft haven't yet found
but there are tools at least to find the
most obvious of those bugs and we're
going to introduce you now to a program
called valren so valren it's a fairly
fancy program but we'll use it for very
simple ways we'll look at your code and
find memory errors as it's executing and
try to help you understand where they
are so let me go back to vs code here
memory seems to be fine you know I feel
like okay I'm going to submit this
homework all is good no error messages
that's no longer the case now you need
to poke a little more at your code to
see if maybe there's still some bug
there so let me do this
valren and then space dotmemory so just
like debug 50 you run it on a program
you already compiled valren I'm going to
run it on a program I already compiled
let me uh zoom in on my terminal window
so we can see more at once and enter all
right the output is crazy cryp IC for no
good reason there's lots of numbers and
equal signs it's a lot of clutter but
there is some juicy information here and
let me start from the top down invalid
write of size four so write means to
change a value read means to like access
a value and this is again esoteric like
a lot of our error messages are but it
looks like uh after a block of size 12
allock and then there's these weird hex
notation there's some mention of malok
but honestly the juicy part here is
memory. C line six that's probably my
fault so let's look at line six per that
output let me shrink the terminal window
look at line six okay 12 is now Germain
right if you did the mental math of the
size of an INT times three 12 is somehow
involved here but line six is now uh
happening next year that's where the
memory came from what is this let me
Zoom back in where is there invalid
right of size four like what's perhaps
going wrong here invalid right of size
four what does that mean it's like a
very technical way of explaining the bug
is actually one line later on line seven
as we already identified
yeah indeed and I I misspoke a moment
ago the bug actually arises here with
line nine so after the allocation of
memory I'm somehow writing four bytes
incorrectly and unfortunately the onus
is kind of on you to sort of think
through deductively like what could that
mean but I'm clearly touching four bytes
of memory in these few lines of code
that I shouldn't be and hopefully here
is the light bulb already went off ear
oh I'm not zero indexing okay that must
mean that X bracket 3 as you note is
just too far past the chunk of memory so
I'm invalidly writing to four bytes that
I shouldn't be so again it's not super
obvious this is not super userfriendly
but at least it does give you a clue as
to where that bug is so the fix there is
going to be quite simply to change the
one to a zero the two to a one and the
three to a two that'll fix that but
there's still a second error and let me
look at the cryptic output again Heap
summary some stuff there okay this does
not sound good down here 12 bytes in one
blocks are definitely lost in Lost
record one of one very Arcane output two
but clearly related to line six again
our allocation of memory now here too
it's not obvious what the solution is
but memory is lost AKA this is a memory
leak and now the deductions kind of up
to you why what is leak oh wait I didn't
call free and so the second solution
here is probably to free x at the very
end of the program and if you really
want to be you should probably check
like I proposed earlier if x is null
just get out now while you still can and
don't even touch those other lines of
code but if you get to the bottom return
zero but really the takeaways are I
fixed my zero indexing of the array to
avoid the invalid right of size four and
now I'm freeing the memory that I asked
for so there should be no leak lost all
right let's try this again make
memorymemory no visible errors yet but
let me now increase my terminal window
again do valren of dotmemory crossing my
fingers and now all Heap blocks were
freed no leaks are possible I don't see
any invalid rights there's still a crazy
amount of output but none of it is
erroneous it's not bad now I fixed my
memory bugs and so now my my ta my TF
they're not going to find them either
because at least valr has proactively
done that for me questions then on
valgren generally it's those two types
of Errors you might trip over there's
not twoo much else in the way of Arcane
output questions then on
this no all right well what else might
be going on so someone alluded to this
earlier what happens when you for
instance forget the null Terminator or
you generally start poking around memory
that you yourself didn't ask for or uh
looking at values you didn't put there
well let me go ahead and open this code
of garbage. C in honor of Oscar the
Grouch here of sorts and here is a
simple program if I hide my terminal
window that just does something kind of
arbitrary I first declare an array uh
called scores uh but I made it crazy big
like 1024 like that's a lot of uh
integers but so be it and then I iterate
over those integers and I print each of
those scores out so I'm using week two
syntax here but based on this program
what have I clearly not done that I did
do back in week two I've allocated the
array I'm printing the array but but
Bute yeah I didn't initialize any values
for that array back in week two we
didn't do 1024 we did like three and I
typed in like three test scores or
something like that he here I'm
allocating memory even more than that
just because I really want to be
dramatic with what I'm demonstrating but
I'm not initializing those values to
anything and so here it turns out in C
generally if you do not initialize a
variable or you do not initialize an
array with explicit values there are
going to be garbage values there so to
speak remnants of that memory having
been used before probably by some other
function of yours some Library function
or something else while your program is
running not a huge deal with a super
small program like this but for anything
sizable memory is going to be used and
unused and used and unused that is
macked and freed again and again there's
going to be lots of garbage values in
the computer's memory by default so if I
open my terminal window here uh let me
do make garbage uh let me zoom in on my
terminal so we can see the output when I
runt garbage theoretically I should see
1,24 integers but none of which have
been initialized now I'm going to get
lucky with some of them and it looks
like wow okay a lot of them are
initialized to zero and C does in some
context initialize memory for you to
zero at least at the beginning but not
again and again typically but if I start
scrolling backwards in time at this
array of size
1024 where did these values come from so
just random positive and negative
numbers interspersed among the zeros
well that's because I'm literally poking
around a random 1,24 bytes of the
computer's memory who knows what's there
so the lesson here is that garbage
values are indeed this like term of art
it means that a variable that you might
have uh defined that you might have
declared if you don't give it an
explicit value who knows what's going to
be there and the lesson here is just
don't do that always initialize
variables to something either yourself
or prompting the human for
it questions about garbage
values you'll see them sometimes if you
print things you shouldn't or touch
arrays beyond their
boundaries all right so maybe to make
this a little visual too it turns out
that a lot of things can go wrong
unfortunately with poers and we've seen
some of them and here's another program
that's a little contrived it's very
simple and it just is about manipulating
values it doesn't do anything useful per
se except demonstrate some of today's
Concepts so in main here let me propose
that we declare a pointer called X
that's going to store eventually the
address of an integer apparently here's
another one called y that's going to
store the address of an integer as well
here now I'm allocating enough memory to
fit one integer now technically it's
four we know that but size of in just
gives me that answer dynamically so it
will work on all systems
and I'm going to store the address that
Malo finds for me in X then I go to x
and put the number 42 there all right
why it's the sort of meaning of life the
universe and everything here but star X
again just means go to that address and
put a value there so why I don't know
but it's just uh correct at this point
but what about this line here star y
equals 13 unlucky in this case what's
bad about this line here star y It's a
combination now of today's Primitives
and that point here
yeah yeah we didn't ask the computer to
allocate any space so why was not
initialized with an equal sign at any
point to anything and so what is inside
y so to speak like a garbage value maybe
it's zero which isn't bad because at
least it's nice and simple but maybe
it's some crazy large uh positive number
some crazy large negative number either
way odds are if I go to this address or
that address randomly with star y bad
things are going to happen and so let me
go ahead and propose well let's not do
that let's let's actually do this
instead assign y equal to X and we've
done that before and then I can go to Y
now and change what was a 42 to a 13
again why this is just for educational
sake but for now this does not crash
because I only dreference y with star y
after actually giving it a value albe it
a duplicate value similar to our copy
example earlier so our friends at
Stanford have put together a wonderful
visual it's about 2 minutes long allow
me to dramatically dim the lights if we
could and play with what happens with
memory when you do bad things like
[Music]
this hey Binky wake up it's time for
pointer fun what's that learn about
pointers Oh goodie well to get started I
guess we're going to need a couple
pointers okay this code allocates two
pointers which can point to integers
okay well I see the two pointers but
they don't seem to be pointing to
anything that's right initially pointers
don't point to anything the things they
point to are called Pointes and setting
them up is a separate step oh right
right I knew that the Pointes are
separate or so how do you allocate a
point e okay well this code allocates a
new integer point and this part sets X
to point to it hey that looks better so
make it do something okay I'll
dereference the pointer X to store the
number 42 into its Point e for this
trick I'll need my magic wand of
dereferencing your magic wand of D
referencing uh that that's great this is
what the code looks like I'll just set
up the number
and hey look there it goes so doing a d
reference on X follows the arrow to
access its Point T in this case to store
42 in there hey try using it to store
the number 13 through the other pointer
why okay I'll just go over here to Y and
get the number 13 set up and then take
the wand of d referencing and
just oh hey that didn't work say uh
Binky I don't think de referencing Y is
a good idea cuz uh you know setting up
the point T is a separate step and uh I
don't think we ever did it good point
yeah we we allocated the pointer y but
we never set it to point to a point
T very observant hey you're looking good
there Binky can you fix it so that y
points to the same point as X sure I'll
use my magic wand of pointer assignment
is that going to be a problem like
before no this doesn't touch the Pointes
it just changes one pointer to point to
the same thing is another oh I see now y
points to the same place as X so so wait
now Y is fixed it has a point e so you
can try the wand of D referencing again
to send the 13 over uh okay here it
goes hey look at that now D referencing
works on why and because the pointers
are sharing that one point e they both
see the 13 yeah sharing uh whatever so
are we going to switch places now oh
look we're out of time but L thanks to
Professor Nick parlante of Stanford for
spending a huge amount of time doing
stop motion animation for that but
hopefully now you have a sense of what
two can go wrong when you misuse memory
in this way but at the end of the day we
really only have these four new building
blocks today like the star operator the
Ampersand operator malok and free and
really with that and the underlying
understanding of what your computer is
doing underneath the hood we have this
way now to really manipulate things in
memory For Better or For Worse and
eventually we'll see how we can build
things but we can also now use today's
Primitives to better explain some things
that we've been asking you to take for
granted over the past several weeks so
for instance let me propose that we uh
do one volunteer up here if we could
could we get one volunteer who's you
want to come straight up yep right in
the middle come on you'll have to take a
left right
there
all right so we have two empty glasses
here and two colors of liquid and we
have let me give you the mic if you'd
like to say hello to the
group hello um I'm Moen uh I'm in the
and first year all right welcome well
well welcome here I'm going to go ahead
and fill these two glasses with this
colored liquid um purple here on my
right let's fill up a glass
here yeah don't drink uh and now we'll
put some orange in here
and what we'd like you to do for the
audience if you don't mind is swap the
two values we've got a purple value and
orange value and I'd like the purple
liquid in this glass and the orange
liquid in that glass
please can I have another glass oh okay
good intuition but for the microphone uh
can I have another glass so you can and
just in fact I brought one here for you
why are you asking for this though cuz
if I just pour this into this and it'll
get mixed up right so obviously we need
like a temporary variable if you will so
here is your temporary
variable and you want yeah there's
yeah all right so pouring the value of
the orange glass into this temporary
variable if you
will all right and now pouring the value
of the purple glass into the former
orange
glass and
now the temporary value goes back into
the original purple glass and now I
think we give you a round of applause
for having done that very well
okay thank you all right so so it should
go without saying that in the real world
like that's how you do this and in fact
in code that's pretty much how you have
to do this although ask us some time for
a super fancy way of doing it without a
temporary variable turns out that is
possible using bits but for now let's
suppose that indeed this demonstrates
what is the reality in code if you want
to swap two values you need to have have
something like a temporary variable so
for instance on the screen here is a uh
the beginning of a function called swap
whose purpose in life is to as you just
did swap two values call it a and b so
orange and purple respectively are now
just a and b and integers to keep things
simple well here is the corresponding
code if I may to what you just enacted
as a human you declared a temporary
variable a called temp in this case
which was like me handing you The Empty
Glass and you stored the orange liquid
in it akaa you then changed the value of
the formerly orange glass to be equal to
the Purple by pouring one into the other
and then you did the opposite there now
at the end of this you still have a
temporary variable that's now empty so
it's temporary in literally that sense
like you just don't need it anymore but
it was necessary along the way so I dare
say this code is correct logically like
this will swap two values A and B thanks
to the use of that temporary variable
unfortunately though if I actually do
this in practice let me go over to VSS
code here and open a program I wrote in
advance called swap. C which does this
as follows in here notice I have my
prototype for a swap function at the
very top and let me scroll down to the
very bottom there is that exact same
code so I'm uh the same code for
swapping two values A and B which I'm
claiming for now is correct now if I go
back up here what is main going to do
for us main is really just meant to be a
demonstration of the correctness of your
algorithm so here I declare on line
seven and eight two variables X and Y
being 1 and two arbitrarily respectively
I then on line 10 just print out what
the value of x is and Y is just so I can
see it on the screen I then call the
swap function on line 11 and then I
literally print the exact same thing
again I print X and Y hopefully it'll
obviously be the opposite so I think
logically swap is indeed correct let me
do make Swap and then do/ Swap and I
should see X is one y is 2 and then
hopefully X is 2 Y is 1 enter but I
don't and it did work in the sense that
the code compiled the code ran so it's
not like some bug in that sense but
because I don't quite understand what's
going on underneath the hood at least as
of right now or prior weeks this code
here is indeed buggy in some way but
does anyone have an intuition perhaps
based on today's discussion is to like
why this code while logically correct
clearly works in reality apparently does
not work in
C any intuition
yeah perfect and to summarize here's
that term of art I prom
when you call a function and pass in two
arguments Like A and B you're passing
those arguments by value so copies of
those values effectively and so when
swap is actually called here sorry when
you pass in X and Y we call them A and B
but that's just a convention we could
call the parameters anything we want
what A and B are are indeed the values
of X and Y respectively but copies of
the values so this code here is very
successfully in vs code 2 swapping the
values of a A and B but as you note
because I'm passing them in by value
literally one literally two and not by
another term of art by reference AKA by
their addresses swap has no capability
in C to go to those locations swap the
actual locations just like we did
successfully in reality but I think we
really have the syntax already for
solving this if we consider that really
this is just an issue of scope and we've
talked a bit about scope in the past
whereby scope refers to the context in
which a variable lives and generally
I've claimed that a variable exists
between the most recent curly braces and
that's pretty much true for the swap
function because a and b i now claim
again exist only in the context of these
curly braces they have no effect on Main
up top which has different variables X
and Y but we can consider now what's
really going on underneath the hood and
here's that same picture of memory as
we've seen in the past if we zoom in and
see on these little black chips this is
a bunch of bites of memory if I create a
grid out of it just to kind of highlight
that we can address each of these bites
throw away the plastic circuit board and
focus only on those bites what's going
on underneath the hood when functions
are called in C which you've been doing
for weeks now well this rectangle of
memory if we kind of abstract it away
further is generally broken up into
different regions or segments like I
called them earlier and different things
get put in different parts of the
computer's memory and without getting
too into the weeds when you double click
a program on your macro PC or when you
do/ something on a Linux you are loading
your machine code into the computer's
memory from the computer's hard drive so
all the zeros and ones that compose
Microsoft Word or Chrome or whatever are
loaded into the computer's memory or RAM
and by convention it's put up top in the
so-called machine code area and that's
how the CPU has access to them quickly
at that below that are what are be going
to be our globals so Global variables
which we haven't used very much in C but
you can declare them outside of main at
the very top of your files if you have
globals they end up up there as well
just FYI and then there's this big chunk
of memory that we saw valgren mention
indirectly earlier called the Heap and
it's kind of like Heap literally like
it's a heap of memory that you can use
as you see fit and the Heap is where
malok grabs memory from so initially
there's nothing in the Heap it's just a
big chunk of free space anytime you call
malok Malo kind of carves out from the
Heap area more and more bites and Malo
keeps track of essentially which bites
have already been allocated so initially
it looks empty but different bites
squares if you will keep getting
requested again and again as a program
runs thanks to functions like malok and
it grows if you will conceptually down
so the more and more memory you request
from malok it starts up here but then
the next chunk you get is down here
conceptually the next chunk is down here
down here so it kind of fills the
available space in the computer's
overall memory but there's this other
chunk of memory called the stack and
just like a stack of trays in like
annenburg or a cafeteria kind of grow
upward so does the stack of memory and
it turns out the stack is where
functions have variables and have
arguments stored temporarily so whenever
you call a function and it has variables
inside of it or it has arguments there
too this is the chunk of memory and the
computer's overall block of memory that
are used for functions but anytime you
call malok it's memory up here right at
the end of the day they just had to pick
a direction top bottom and technically
it's an artist rendition you could
Circle this thing around any orientation
you want but you're just using a finite
amount of memory in this conventional
way Malo Starts Here functions start
here now you can kind of see where like
bad things can happen and indeed one of
the other reasons programs computers can
crash is if you ask for way too much
memory from the Heap by calling malok
many many many times or if you call way
too many functions or accidentally per
last week you recurse infinitely many
times you might have a segmentation
fault and that's because you're using
too much stack memory so this is bound
to be a problem eventually and the onus
is on the programmer to just minimize
the probability of doing that and really
avoid the possibility of doing that by
just checking return values like
checking if malok or get string return
null because you can proactively with
conditionals make sure that these two
things do not Collide by just making
sure that you get back non-null values
so let's consider the stack in the
context of Swap and what's really
happening here and Carter if you
wouldn't mind helping me animate the
screen here when I call the main
function of any program it is allocated
a slice of memory called a frame at the
bottom of this stack so if Carter you
want to go ahead and uh Advance here
here's like the First Slice of memory
that will always be used by main whether
it has commandline arguments or local
variables it just ends up here in memory
suppose now per our swap. C program that
main calls swap well where does the
memory for swap end up like right up
here so swap had two variable two
arguments uh A and B and it also had a
temporary variable so all of those end
up in here in memory and if you want to
go ahead and Advance again Carter once
swap is done executing whether it just
returns because there's no more lines of
code or you explicitly return this
memory is just freed up automatically
you don't call free you don't undo malok
this just all happens automatically and
has been since week one now technically
it's still there even though we've
removed it from the picture and there's
your first hint of garbage values right
like there's still zeros and ones there
and they're left in the original the
previous configuration and so the reason
you get random values in the memory is
because even though we hav't drawn swap
here there was stuff there a moment ago
it's going to be there the next time you
use that same memory now let's go ahead
and step through this a little more
methodically main has two variables
called X and Y one and two so let's
advance and represent X is one y is two
taking up these two chunks of memory
when we call swamp now swamp gets a new
slice of memory that then gives us three
variables A and B technically the
arguments and temp so what happens well
because functions automatically pass in
values by value or rather pass in
arguments by value X gets copied into a
y gets copied into B and then once we
start executing the algorithm all the
watered glasses well what happens here
so if I execute the first line of code
temp equals a temp gets a copy of a what
happens next a equals B so a takes on a
copy of B and now we do the final swap
in the glasses b equals temp b gets a
copy of temp now we don't have to change
temp because it's essentially empty
although there's the garbage value one
is always now going to be there until we
reuse that memory the important thing
though is that a and b have been swapped
but what obviously has not been swapped
as is Manifest is when swap returns X
and Y are untouched because copies
thereof were passed in so we need a
solution to this problem and if we
advance one more time if you don't mind
let me step over here but then call you
back in a second this code here is
logically correct this is what you did
but this is now a detail of C you can't
just swap the things by value because
you're only changing it in the scope of
the swap function function but I think
if we change it to this and add some
annoying syntax we can solve the problem
just like you can declare variables as
storing addresses you can declare
arguments to functions AKA parameters as
taking addresses this new version of
swap means that a shall be the address
of an integer B shall be the address of
an integer and now it gets a little
cryptic here temp is the same because
it's just an integer like it was in week
one nothing special about temp but if
you want to get the value at a you do
star a and that goes to the address
grabs the number one presumably if you
want to change the value of a you go to
that address you follow the treasure map
to the other mailbox and you set it
equal to whatever is at the value of B
you go to B as well last line you go to
B now and change it to be whatever the
temporary variable was which happened to
be the same as a so that's where the
final value gets swapped but here
there's a lot more like crisscrossing
metaphorically across the stage where
you're going to all of these different
addresses in the swap function to make
these changes so if we advance now to
the pictoral version of this here's the
same story as before with Maine and X
and Y are 1 and two respectively when
swap gets called now notice and I'll do
it with arrows here a is effectively
pointing to X B is effectively pointing
to Y if we really get into the weeds
these are actually like addresses but
who cares about the specifics it's
really just the concept here so now what
happens in temp gets star a star a means
start at a and go there Follow the arrow
if you will sort of shoots in ladder
Style and then that's one so we put one
and 10th all right star a equals star B
so let's do it from right to left star b
means Follow the arrow it's two and then
what do you do Follow the arrow it's now
two because you copy one to the other
from right to left and then lastly star
b gets temp so start at B go to B and
now store whatever the value is in temp
so just by having this basic new syntax
of like ampersands and stars and so
forth we can actually now go to places
and circumvent what is otherwise a
feature of C that these variables are
locally scoped but you can still access
things in other functions as well so
thank you so much for helping step
through this so we now have a
application of this that explains why
now in this version of the C code this
would actually now work so in fact let
me go back to my swap code here and let
me change the function ever so slightly
in vs code so let me scroll down leaving
main the same and let me change swaps
prototype to taking in addresses let me
go to a here let me go to a here let me
go to B here and let me go to B here as
well but nothing else changes this
change here in particular is enough of a
clue to see that means when you call
Swap and pass into values I'm expecting
addresses now not integers but now that
I've made this change I do need to go up
to Main and make one change does anyone
have the intuition for what now need
change in main so that I pass in X and Y
by reference that is by address rather
than than by value or copy oh yeah and
[Music]
back so close so on the swap line it's
not star that I want in front of the X
and the Y it's
instead what's the other one it's the
Amper sand why because if I want to
enable swap to go somewhere just like
Carter and I played this game with the
mailboxes I need to inform swap of the
address of X and the address of Y and
again per the beginning of today's class
Ampersand is the text via which we do
that so I add an ampersand here to get
the address of X Ampersand here to get
the address of Y and now this code lines
up with the picture that Carter just
helped us walk through and so when I run
make swap here I have a mistake oh what
did I do wrong not intentional but I
guess worth pointing out I screwed up
here it doesn't like Ampersand
X because of something on line three
which is way early in the code what did
I screw up yeah in the middle
yeah so this is why we you should not
copy paste even though it's necessary
for things like function prototypes if I
change swap at the bottom I need to
change its prototype so let me add the
star there add the star there or just
recopy paste it at the top of the file
now let me do make swap again let me now
do do/ Swap and I should now see X is
one y is 2 and hopefully X is 2 Y is 1
which I now do so the logic is the same
the algorithm is the same all the weak
zero stuff is the same except now and
four you just have a bit more
expressiveness via which you can tell
the computer exactly what you want to
manipulate and how any questions then on
this technique
here no all right well when we fix this
there's still going to be problems and
just so you've seen some terms of art
here this is bad whenever you have two
arrows pointing at one another certainly
if you might use and reuse more and more
memory and it turns out there's some
terms of art that might suddenly now
make sense especially if you've
programmed before bad things Can Happen
by this design but there's really only
this kind of design because it's a
finite amount of memory so at some point
bad things are going to happen no matter
what if a computer runs out of memory so
it's not that this was a poor decision
it's just sort of a necessary one given
finite amounts of memory in a computer
but a heap overflow so to speak is when
you actually overflow the Heap and touch
memory that you shouldn't up there stack
Overflow is when you somehow overflow
the stack and touch memory that you
shouldn't down there so with that said
these are really just problems that can
happen and there specific incarnations
of what are generally called buffer
overflows a buffer like in the YouTube
sense is just like a chunk of memory
that in the case of YouTube stores like
the next few seconds or minutes of video
but generally speaking a buffer is just
a chunk of memory that the computer is
using for some purpose be it the stack
be it the Heap be it an array in the
computer and so buffer overflows are
what happens when you just have logical
bugs in your code but with these
Primitives now in mind we wanted to
conclude with a final Revelations and
that's how some functions like these
here work the other thing in the cs50
library besides the type def for quote
unquote string is of course all of these
functions and we give you these
functions because honestly in C it is
hard it's annoying it's painful it's
difficult to get user input correctly
it's very easy when you don't know how
much how much the humans going to type
to write buggy code when it comes to it
and indeed it's really hard to store it
correctly without accidentally having
some kind of buffer overflow so for
instance let me show you a program here
I'm going to go ahead and write this one
from scratch so let me go ahead and open
a file called get. C where I'm going to
go ahead and mimic the idea of getting
integers manually without the cs50
library so I'm going to include standard
io. only I'm going to Define main as not
taking any command line arguments and
then I'm going to do something like this
give me a variable x with no value yet
and normally I would do something like
get int but let me take that away no
more training wheels for get int either
so let me just Define the int X let me
then just print out something like uh a
prompt and I'll just do x c just to make
it obvious to the human what we're
waiting for and now I'm going to use a
builtin c function to get user input I'm
going to call a function called scan F
which sort of scans the user's keyboard
for input I'm going to scan it for an
integer so just like print F I'm going
to use percent I because I expect an INT
and then I want to tell scanf where to
put the human's integer from the
keyboard it is not correct though to say
x because if I say x I run into the same
swap problem scanf no function can
change the value of X unless I pass it
not by value but
by reference so we're back to our
Ampersand friend and now it has like a a
treasure map to the actual location of X
and can therefore change it and so now
at the very end of this program let me
do something simple like let's just go
ahead and print out with print F uh the
value of x using percent I as always
plugging in X not Ampersand X this is
now week one stuff I want to print the
actual integer value of x so the only
change here is that instead of using get
in I'm now using this new function that
as of today exists called scanf so let
me go ahead and run get make get to
create this program doget and let's go
ahead and type in a value for x 50 enter
and it just works so it turns out get in
is pretty simple to implement however
notice what does not work if I type in
cat for instance cat gets converted to
zero and meanwhile get in recall will
reprompt the user if a human not type an
actual integer you get automatically
reprompt so that's one of the features
we for cs50 added to get in just to make
your programs more user friendly but
otherwise get in is pretty
straightforward to re-implement using
scanf unfortunately that's not true for
Strings because how do you know when you
write your code what word the human's
going to eventually type in how long
they're greeting like high is if it's uh
if their name is David or Carter or
anything else you just don't know in
advance how much memory you need so how
might we do this in with string well let
me go ahead and declare a string s
although you know what there's no cs50
Library so we do Char star s today
instead and that gives me not a string
per se but a pointer that will Point
presumably to a string ideally I would
use this get string but again we've
taken that training wheel away so now
that I have a pointer s suppose I prompt
the human for a value for S just like
before let me use scan F now and tell
the user that I expect to read a string
percent s from the keyboard
uh and store it in s now this is subtle
I don't technically need an Amper sand
here even though I did for an INT and I
would for a float and a double and a
long and a bull and a Char why do I not
need an Amper sand in this story to pass
by
reference because s is it's already an
address again strings are just special
strings now are always addresses so you
don't need to additionally add an Amper
sand here that's the only subtle
difference here but now if I go ahead
and print out at the very end what the
value of s is using percent S as before
this program looks like it's almost the
same as the int version but let's do
make get and okay so this is not good
all right so it doesn't like an
initialized value so let me make it
happy I said earlier to always
initialize my variable so let's
initialize it to null so that at least
something is there that's your good
default value nowadays now if I do doget
now we're good and let me type in
something like cat
okay cat is not X well let me try
another word maybe it's just cat is
wrong dog okay let me try David it just
doesn't seem to be working moreover it's
printing it as a zero what logically
though is the bug here scanf worked a
moment ago for integers but it's not
working for Strings and it seems to be
forgetting C A it's forgetting dog it's
forgetting
David
why what's Happening
Here think back to our yellow pictures
of
memory when I
yeah it might be reading just the null
itself because s is being initialized to
null and what step have I forgotten from
just like a few minutes ago what did I
not actually request of the computer
like actual memory to store the C A the
dog the d v d right there's nowhere have
I asked the computer for some amount of
memory and so technically it might be
reading it into some garbage location
and that's really the problem here S is
initialized to null now and so in fact
it is printing zero as null but I'm not
seeing any of the other letters because
there was nowhere to put them C A do D
ID because I didn't ask for three bytes
four bytes five bytes 100 bytes there's
no use of malok there's no use of an
array there's no memory allocated for
anything other than the pointer itself
and this is where honestly life gets
hard with scanf like I could solve this
problem in a couple of ways let me go
ahead and do this instead of declaring s
to be a pointer let me declare s to
actually be a an array of four chars and
now let me go ahead and recompile the
code so make get doget and I'll type in
cat now that now works why well I'm
allocating an explicit array of size
four enough for a one two three letters
plus a null character here's where to
someone's question earlier it turns out
then in some context you can treat
arrays as though they are Pointers
themselves see we'll sort of do the
conversion for you but for now just
assume that s is just an array of size
four and if you pass it into to scanf
that's like a treasure map that leads to
those four bytes so scanf can now
successfully fill it with c a d o but
but let's try this again let's type in
David and here okay we got lucky but I
technically touched memory that I should
not and in fact if I typed in a long
enough string and I don't think I could
do it very easily like by without typing
this thousands or hundreds of times
still okay but you'll notice that it's
forgotten the rest of it now right so
somewhere we went beyond the boundary of
the array and we just don't have enough
storage space for that entire thing so
what do you do in your program if you
don't know how long the person's name or
the the the animal name is going to be
what do you do 40 400 4,000 40,000 like
at some point you have to draw a line in
the sand and that's why like getting
user input is so annoying in a language
like C and that's why get string exists
what we do if you're curious is we look
at the user's input and we take baby
steps we look at it one character at a
time and every time we see another
character we actually call malok again
and say no I need more than one bite I
need two oh wait they typed in three
letters I need three instead of two oh I
need four instead of two and we have
this crazy loop essentially that keeps
asking for more and more memory but by
taking baby steps and honestly if you
all had to do that in week one my God
like we couldn't even write hello world
anymore and so that's why these training
wheels exist at least early on and
that's why in higher level languages
like in uh python you don't have to do
this at all it just works as you'd
expect so what more can we do well
you'll see in problems set for this
coming week if I open up an example like
this phone book. C you'll see that you
can manipulate files now that you have a
vocabulary for pointers it's going to be
new quickly but here we have an example
of how I have a program using some
familiar libraries here but as I claim
in my comment this saves names and
numbers to a CSV file all of my examples
thus far I type in some words I type in
some names and some phone numbers and
they disappear because we only store
them in memory but if you want to store
data in like a CSV file comma separated
values which is like a simple
spreadsheet like Excel and apple numbers
and Google Sheets can open you can
actually do this yourself so just as a
teaser for this week here on line n I'm
using a new data type not a cs50 thing
this is a c thing called file but if you
want to manipulate files you need to use
addresses that is pointers so here is me
creating a variable called file that's
going to point to an actual file on the
hard drive on the server or your Mac or
PC fop is going to be a new function
you'll use that will open open a file
and it will return effectively a pointer
there to in memory the file name I want
to open is phonebook .csv and in this
example it's going to be uh a pen mode
it will keep allowing me to add more and
more names and numbers to this file
here's some old get string stuff because
I'm not going to reinvent get string
with scan F but down here is a slightly
new function it's not print F but
fprintf and it turns out it's very easy
to print things not to the screen but to
a file with fprintf and it takes an
additional argument instead of starting
with the quoted string you'll have to
like say what file you want to write to
and fr print F we'll figure out how to
get the uh the bits into that file
passing in something like name comma
number so if I run this somewhat quickly
here let me do this let me pre-create a
file called uh phonebook do CSV and in
phone book. CSV I'm going to create a
temporary row here name comma number
just so that there's something in this
file and now let me go ahead and do this
and split my screen here if I have
phonebook.com
and phone book. C on the left let me
compile make phonebook which is the C
version phonebook and now I'm prompted
for a name and a number so I'll type in
David and then for instance + one
949 uh what is it 468 275 o enter oh
damn it bug uh pretend that didn't
happen I forgot to hit enter in the file
so let's do this again if I run the
program Again David and plus one 94 9
468 2750 enter it's been saved now to
the file and if I close this file and I
reopen code of phonebook.com
or the like and I've actually created an
actual CSV file uh if you're smiling
because I keep repeating my phone number
out loud I would encourage you to call
or text that number sometime it might
very well well be a an Easter egg of
source but via these functions here do
we have now the ability to write files
uh input and output and among the goals
then for this week as we'll see are to
actually play with images in the spirit
of something like Instagram filters or
the like and we'll introduce you for
instance to a file format called bmps
which to come full circle to the start
of class are just maps of bits but more
than just single bits for white and
black but rather colorful patterns as
well and we'll give you images like this
of the week's Bridge here across the
river at Harvard and you've run
after writing your own code in C and
understanding how the data stored in the
computer's memory you'll be able to
apply your own Instagram like filters to
make things uh grayscale instead or
sepia in this case you can even flip the
bits around so that the thing is a
mirror image you can blur things further
or if you really are feeling more
comfortable you can even write code that
finds the edges of the image and creates
works of art like these so all that in
more in problem set four we will see you
next
time
[Music]
all right this is cs50 and this is week
five which is going to be our last week
in see uh but what that means is that
we'll have
okay
but with this week with last week and
really all of the weeks prior have you
been hopefully acquiring if slowly and
with some challenge like some
fundamental building blocks that are
still going to underly everything we
continue doing in the semester even as
we transition to so-called higher level
languages next week indeed we'll
introduce python a very popular language
that does not have pointers does not
have memory management at this very low
level but that's really just because
someone else wrote the code that will do
that for you and it's going to make our
lives easier because it means when you
want to solve a problem concept up here
to just get real work done or build
something amazing you don't have to
really get into the same weeds as we
have been deliberately this week and now
last but the goal ultimately is that you
better understand and can better harness
than all that a computer can do even in
those higher level languages So today
we're going to focus particularly on
data structures how you might structure
your data in memory which really amounts
to building things digitally stitching
together ideas and Concepts in memory
using this new building block from last
week which of course are these pointers
pointers allow you to store addresses in
memory like in variables but with those
simple addresses we can sort of leave
these breadcrumbs we can point from here
to there and we can conceptually stitch
pieces of data together but there's
going to be different ways of doing that
and today we'll focus first on what's
generally known as an abstract data type
and similar to a type in C more
generally it does actually have some
properties in it but the underlying
implementation details of an abstract
data type are ultimately up to you that
is to say an abstract data type can
represent one thing and can do something
but how you implement it allows you some
discretion underneath the hood so for
instance in the world of computer
science a q is actually a technical term
this is a type of data structure that we
could theoretically build in code in C
or really any other language but a q has
properties just like cu's in the real
world for instance if you've ever lined
up for something to get food in a uh and
get food in a restaurant or go into a
store or wait for the airport to clear
you well you've lined up in a queue Q
being some sort of line but what's
noteworthy about Q's are specific
properties they are first in first out
data structures either virtually or in
the human world which is to say the
first person in the line should ideally
be served first at the restaurant or the
first person in the line should get
through airport security first by
contrast if it weren't first in first
out you can imagine how frustrated you
would be if you have this sort of
inherent unfairness in fact if you've
ever been in line at a store a
supermarket or the like and all of a
sudden they maybe open a new line and
now the person behind you gets to kind
of cut ahead and go forward that's
because they've broken the concept of
the cube so it has this inherent
potential for unfairness unless you
maintain this first in first out
property this would be true too for like
a to-do list just for productivity sake
if you're in the habit on paper or
virtually making a to-do list ideally
you probably want to go through that
list top to bottom so that you actually
get the first stuff you thought of done
first rather than always focusing on
your most recent thought now within the
world of Q's there's generally two
operations two functions if you will
that any Q would have either in the real
world or in the virtual NQ is usually
the technical term to mean adding
something to a q but specifically it
means adding it to the end of the que so
that someone isn't cutting in line for
instance to go up front and then DQ is
just the opposite when it's time for the
first person in line to be served the
time for the first person in line to go
through security they are dced so to
speak so technical concept ultimately as
it's implemented in code but it's really
just a real world concept and these are
in contrast to another abstract data
type that we might call a stack and a
stack much like a stack of trays in the
cafeteria has sort of fundamentally
different properties you can still add
and remove things from them but consider
what happens whenever they clean all the
trays in the cafeteria or the dining
hall they put one of the trays down here
and then the next one on top of it and
then the next one on top of it it it and
so forth but of course which tray do you
presume presumably take as a user of
that physical
stack the top one presumably right like
you're not going to fuss down here and
try to pull one out and so that would
seem to have an opposite property lifo
last in first out is what characterizes
something like a stack and that just
makes sense certainly in the physical
world of stacking all of those cafeteria
trays because it just makes more sense
to grab the most recently added one the
last added one first and at least in
that context the trays don't necessarily
care what order they're using used in
but even then you could imagine that
maybe there's some old dirty nasty tray
at the very bottom that like never gets
used because you're constantly
replenishing the stack so there might
very well be side effects of these kinds
of features um you might be familiar
with using Gmail for instance or really
any email program what you're looking at
in your inbox is technically a stack at
least if you've left the defaults
configured why you get a new email where
does it end up not like five pages of
emails later presumably right at the top
and the next one's right at the top
right at the the top right at the top
and so if you're like me you're guilty
of eventually losing track of some
emails why because you've pushed so many
more emails onto the stack that you sort
of lose track of the things you got
earliest last in first out though is
maintained the most recent email you get
might very well be the first one you
reply to but that's not necessarily good
for responsiveness to everyone else out
there uh similarly if you store like all
of your sweaters in a stack like this uh
the uh like a pile of black ones below
which is a red and then a blue stack
might be perfectly fine for keeping
things organized it's sort of the sane
way to do it if you just have a shelf in
your dorm room or home but what's going
to be a side effect of using a stack to
store your sweaters if they're these in
this way as opposed to a queue
yeah it's harder to get the red and blue
one so presumably you're going to much
more often wear for instance if you will
black instead there now the operations
for adding things to a stack are similar
in spirit but just different vocabulary
you push something on top of a stack um
even though it's more like in the tray
world you sort of place it or rest it
but pushing means adding something to
the top of the stack and popping means
some removing something also from the
top of the stack so it's not a matter of
enqing at the end and deqing at the
beginning with a stack everything's
happening on top you're pushing onto the
top and then popping off of the top now
when it comes to actual code how might
we Implement something like this well
let's just focus on really how you might
implement the data structure itself and
we won't Implement any functions you
might implement the notion of a stack
like this we've seen type def before it
just means Define a new type of my own
struct means here comes a structure AKA
a data structure of one or more
variables within and let's suppose like
last time we've had we defined already
like a person data type using a separate
type Def and every person has like a
name and a number or whatever let me
just stipulate that person exists
already so here you might have to
implement a stack an array called people
of some capacity maybe it's an an array
of size 10 or 100 or whatever this is a
constant here in this context capacity
and every element in that array is a
person structure and I now have this to
size now this almost seems like a
synonym for capacity but maybe
intuitively anyone want to propose why
I'm apparently maintaining separately
the capacity of the stack but also the
size of the stack why these two
distinctions
here yeah
perfect the capacity is how high the
stack could be like how much room is
there for those sweatshirts in my closet
for instance whereas size is just
literally at this moment in time how
many sweatshirts are in the stack it's
either capacity or fewer presumably in
total there so what is capacity well we
could implement this in you know perhaps
a familiar way I might just Define a
const somewhere else in my code of type
int that just defines it to be capacity
50 but what perhaps is going to be the
downside of implementing a stack in this
way of how using an array inside here
like what's a downside now of
implementing a stack using an array and
this size variable
within what's a caveat here
perhaps any hands
yeah okay so it's going to be harder to
reach elements that aren't the last one
that is the most recently added one so
there could be some sweatshirts so to
speak way down below so we've seen that
before too but at some point too a
limitation of this design is is what
it's going to be finite right I can
maximally fit in this example 50
sweatshirts or 50 emails or 50 cafeteria
Trace which is fine but at least it's
indeed finite and at least in the
computer's memory it might be nice to
use more and more and more maybe as more
things are getting added to the computer
so maybe I make this 500 or heck why
don't I make it 5,000 or 50,000 well
what's the tradeoff there if I want to
have enough room to grow seems like I
should just crank up the value of
capacity endlessly but why might I not
want to change the 50 to 500 or 5,000 or
50,000 what's the trade-off there
perhaps just intuitively
yeah okay you don't want to touch memory
that you're not supposed to be touching
and in this case it wouldn't be that
wouldn't be a risk per se unless you
indeed overflow the stack but there's a
related issue in asking for that much
memory what would another downside
be yeah okay exactly so if you've got a
capacity of 5,000 but you're only using
one of those elements it's it's awkward
to say it non-technically which is just
to say very very wasteful right that's
just bad design it's correct it will
work for up to 5,000 elements but my
gosh you're wasting
4,999 extra spots and that's not going
to end well especially if you're using
more data structures in memory like your
Mac your PC your phone is surely going
to run out of memory if you ask for that
much so it' be nice if there is a bit
more dynamism there whether it's a stack
or a CU both of which might be
implemented a little similarly in spirit
but let's conclude this abstraction by
comparing thanks to a friend of ours
Professor Shannon Duval of Elon
University who kindly put together this
graphical animation that's just under 2
minutes long that paints a picture of
these two types of abstract data
structures and then we'll dive in
underneath to how we might Implement uh
problems like these if we could dim the
lights
[Music]
dramatically once upon a time there was
a guy named Jack when it came to making
friends Jack did not have the Knack so
Jack went to talk to the most popular
guy he knew he went up to Lou and asked
what do I do Lou saw that his friend was
really distressed well Lou began just
look how you're dressed don't you have
any clothes with a different look yeah
yes said Jack I sure do come to my house
and I'll show them to you so they went
off to Jacks and Jack showed Lou the box
where he kept all his shirts and his
pants and his socks L said I see you
have all your clothes in a pile why
don't you wear some others once in a
while Jack said well when I remove
clothes and socks I wash them and put
them away in the box then comes the next
morning and up I hop I go to the box and
get my clothes off the top Lou quickly
realized the problem with Jack he kept
clothes CDs and books in a stack when he
reached for something to read or to wear
he chose the top book or underwear then
when he was done he would put it right
back back it would go on top of the
stack I know the solution said a
triumphant Lou you need to learn to
start using a queue Lou took Jack's
clothes and hung them in a closet and
when he had emptied the box he just
tossed it then he said now Jack at the
end of the day put your clothes on the
left when you put them away then
tomorrow morning morning when you see
the sun shine get your clothes from the
right from the end of the line don't you
see said Lou it will be so nice you'll
wear everything once before you wear
something twice and with everything in
cues in his closet and shelf Jack
started to feel quite sure of himself
all thanks to Lou and his wonderful
Q all right so sure so that paints a
picture of these two abstract data
structures but if we really were to dive
underneath the hood we could Implement
them in a number of different ways but
we really I think need some building
blocks via which we could solve problems
like those and we'll see today to some
others as well so let's rewind back to
week two where we imple we introduced
you to your very first data structure
that is an array and an array of recall
was just a chunk of memory whereby
elements were stored by Design back to
back to back it's an array of contiguous
memory specifically so with an array we
could certainly store not just one thing
but two or three or even more and so for
instance if we treat uh my computer's
memory as this sort of abstraction here
and pictured here are three bytes or
some uh uh multiplication thereof
suppose we're storing in the computer's
memory an array of size three storing
the digits one two and three well
remember that if we zoom out per last
week there's other stuff going on in
memory so even if we want to add another
number to this array that we didn't
think of when we first started the
program like the number four ideally we
would put it right here next to it
otherwise it's no longer an array so by
definition if we're using an array it's
got to end up right there after the
three but what else is going on inside
of your computer's memory well assuming
your program is of any length and you've
got other variables other functions
you've been running it for a while
there's a lot going on in your memory is
being used and reused so for instance
somewhere in memory might be immediately
adjacent to this like hello comma world
back0 the null character just because
maybe you have another variable
somewhere in there that is storing that
particular string alongside your
existing array of size three and all of
these Oscar the grouches here really
just represent what we called last week
garbage values like there's obviously
bits there because they don't disappear
they're always going to be inside of the
computer somehow implemented but we
don't really know or care what they are
they're the remnants of those bytes
having been used for other older
variables previous function calls or the
like but the problem clearly here is
that okay 1 two 3 is there but the H is
here and unless I want to start uh
taking a bite out of my string by
overriding the H with a four like we
just can't fit it right there and yet
even though there's Oscars all over the
place those are indeed garbage values
and therefore we could use that space
because it's technically unused we just
don't know or care what the values are
so where could I put 1 2 3 4 well my
gosh like I have all this memory down
here that's unused I could certainly
change those garbage values to be 1 2 3
4 but to do that I might need to do a
bit of work here right it's not just a
matter of just saying boom and it
happens now with c and with code I'd
have to do this a little more
methodically so let me abstract away
everything else that's a distraction let
me assume that there is indeed at least
four bytes available for four numbers
just down here though we could have put
them in a bunch of different spots
what's involved now in moving the one
two three to this new chunk of memory so
we can add the four well I think
conceptually we're going to have to copy
the one from old to new copy the two
from old to new copy the three from old
to new and then ultimately we can get
rid of the old memory those three
original bites could now look like Oscar
the Grouch and just be garbage values
for all intents and purposes but now I
have room for a fourth bite wherein I
can put the number four so this is nice
but what's a downside of this
approach what's a downside of solving
the problem in this way where the
problem at hand is just to grow the
array so to speak to increase its size
to fit one or more
numbers seems pretty
straightforward but
yeah okay maybe it's out of order but I
think that's okay because the order is
just matters that it's relative so so
long it's it's still contiguous back to
back to back in a different chunk of
memory I think we're okay there it's not
like I changed it for 4 3 2 one but a
reasonable hunch
yeah yeah like I don't really plan ahead
here like if I have to add another
number like five or anything else well I
might have to jump through these hoops
again maybe I get lucky and maybe
there's space there but not if I have
other variables and other things going
on that too might be used at some point
other thoughts yeah slow efficiency slow
effic in slow efficiency why have
to again yeah I mean it's just in it's
just inefficient it's sort of bad design
arguably why because I had to copy all
of my original work down here and as you
note if I want to add a fifth number I'm
going to have to copy it again and again
and again and do things end times again
and again now maybe that's necessary
we'll soon see for sure but it feels
like this is not going to end well
especially if the array isn't of size
three or four but 300 400 your computer
ends up spending so much time just
spinning its Wheels I mean honestly
better might be this like if this is my
same array physically incarnated Now 1
two 3 it's literally on the edge of the
shelf so there's no room for the number
four you know maybe where we could take
this story is well let's just find room
for the four like let's just put the
four for instance over here replacing
some available garbage value some spare
bite over here but now wait a minute
I've broken the definition of an array
right it's I can't have one two three
and then four over here so maybe there
maybe there could be a mechanism if I
put this thing on again where when you
get to the end of the existing elements
maybe I just somehow digitally point to
the fourth array and maybe we can kind
of stitch together all of these
different values in memory so that if
you follow the arrows so to speak we can
reconstruct exactly what the order is
even without having to find or make room
here or pick up all of these numbers and
move all of them over there so that's
perhaps the direction in which we'll go
here so let's see how we might get to
that spot as follows let me go ahead and
open up say VSS code here let me open up
a program called list. C in my terminal
and let me go ahead and whip up a
relatively simple program that just
demonstrates what we did back in week
two when we introduced arrays as follows
let me include uh standard io. so we can
print stuff out let me do int main void
no command line Arguments for now let me
give myself a an array uh called list of
size three and I'll just hardcode it to
keep it simple for lecture sake Each of
which is going to be an integer and now
just so we have some specifics to talk
about let me put it list bracket zero
the number one list bracket one the
number two and list bracket two the
number three so I'm just translating
into codee what we just had uh
pictorially on the screen and also
physically here with these numbers on
the desk now let's just do something
mildly useful for this how about we do
four in I gets zero I is less than three
I ++ let's just print each of these
numbers out just to make sure they're
indeed in memory as I intended so
percent I back sln comma I and then a
semicolon and I think that's it for now
so nothing interesting no problem solved
just yet just a proof of concept so that
now when I clear my terminal and run
make
list no apparent errors at the terminal
and so when I now do do/ list I should
see hopefully from left to right 1 two 3
but of course if I want to add a fourth
number now there's no mechanism for such
certainly in the code that I just wrote
I could go back in here and change this
to a four I could go down here and
change lists bracket 3 equals 4 I could
just manually change the code recompile
the code but of course that doesn't give
me any additional run way for the fifth
or sixth number so let me try to take a
different approach drawing some
inspiration from last week if I want to
allocate memory dynamically maybe
because I don't know when I wrote the
program how many bytes I want we have
another function as of last week that
does not require that you commit in
advance to a certain number of bytes via
what function can you just ask the
operating system for a chunk of memory
okay so Malo to allocate memory now an
array is just a chunk of memory and even
though since week two 've been using
this syntactic sugar this convenience of
just using square brackets and indexing
into it it's just making it easier to
manipulate a chunk of memory that's
contiguous all together back to back to
back so today just like last week we can
take those sort of training wheels off
and maybe be a little more deliberate in
how we allocate memory let me go for
instance and do this let me delete my
contents of my main function here go
back into Main and let me propose now
that I declare for instance how about my
list no longer as an array but as a
pointer so int star list and I'm going
to go ahead and initialize this to be
how about a chunk of three integers for
now so I'm still going to hardcode it
but I'm taking a step toward more
dynamism for now so let me allocate
three times whatever the size is of an
INT but it's usually going to be four
bytes as we know so this is really going
to be 3 * 4al 12 but it's a little more
Dynamic and now what can I do down here
well this is just a chunk of memory
so I can do literally list bracket 0 uh
equal 1 list bracket 1 = 2 list bracket
2 equals 3 and voila achieve the exact
same effect because again an array is
just a chunk of contiguous memory but
malok gives you any old chunk of
contiguous memory so you can rather
treat one like the other here now if you
really want to be cool you could do
something like this instead you could
dreference the address in list and go
there you could go down here and
dreference list + one and go there but
honestly no one really writes code like
this it's just too cryptic it's a little
too far over the line at least for most
people and so I think the syntactic
sugar as I keep describing it just the
more user friendly square bracket
notation does the exact same thing
figures out the pointer arithmetic and
puts each of these integers in the right
chunks therein now just to be super
pedantic let me make sure if something
went wrong so if list equals equals n
that means that something went wrong
like my computer is out of memory which
we should check for typically so let me
just immediately return one signaling
anything other than zero which means
success typically just to get out of
this program because something's wrong
but now let me propose that I've had a
uh well let's do this for in I gets zero
I less than three i++ though a better
design would always be to use a con but
I'm just doing this for demonstration
sake let's print out each of these ins
too and just make sure I didn't mess
anything up and let me open my terminal
window again let me do make list
again okay huh implicitly declaring
Library function Malo with type void
star something something implicitly de
declaring is the operative words there
what did I mess up
yeah yeah I forgot the header file in
which malok is declared I remember now
okay that's in standard li. and it's
fine to look stuff like that up if you
forget so let me include standard libh
now let me clear my terminal run make
list again okay now we're good /list and
now what did I do
[Music]
wrong oh okay not intended but teachable
moment what did I do wrong
yeah yeah I'm printing the values of i
instead of what is at location I in the
array so what I actually meant to do was
print this out thank you you so now let
me recompile make
listlist and now okay those are the
three values I was expecting not the
indices thereof now let me propose that
for the sake of discussion that I I
regret having only allocated space for
three integers and maybe I really should
have allocated enough space for four now
this is not how you would do this in
practice because presumably if you have
a change of thought just go back in and
correct the code but let me propose that
somewhere in here is a more complicated
program and time passes dot dot dot
there's a lot of other interesting code
there but at some point I might want to
give myself more memory so how can I do
this well let me just ask the operating
system now for four new bytes of memory
so that we can at least in version one
implement the ID on the board where I
just copied the three bytes into the new
four bytes and then added a fourth value
so I'm going to use malok again and I'm
going to say here's a new pointer I'll
call it temp TMP for short which is
quite common when you just need it
briefly I'm going to then call malok
again I'm going to say give me four
integers using size of let me again make
sure so if temp equals equals null
something went wrong so let me just
immediately return one and for good
measure before I return one one let me
free the original list so that I don't
leak memory so I'm not just immediately
returning one I'm being a good citizen
and remembering well if this Malo call
did succeed and indeed I got as far as
line 18 but then line 18 failed I should
free the memory that I previously macked
so again that's the rule of thumb if you
allocate it you should be the one to
free it even before you're about to quit
now once I've done that I think I need
to do what we did pictorially on the
screen where I need to copy the One the
two the three from the old array into
the new so how might I do this well let
me give myself a loop so for in I gets
zero I less than three i++ because the
size of the original is still the same
let me go ahead and treat the new chunk
of memory called 10 temp as an array
itself and so I can absolutely use these
square brackets just like before it's
just a chunk of memory I'm treating it
like an array and let me add to that
value whatever is at the original list
at location I as well so this again is
just this exercise of copying from right
uh from old to new step by step the one
the two and the three but I still need
one additional step if my goal at hand
now is to have ultimately a fourth value
here well I'm just going to hard coose
this for demonstration sake and I'm
going to go to the very last location of
temp which is of size four which means
the last element in temp is temp
bracket three because it's zero indexed
but there's four total spaces there and
I'm just going to arbitrarily for the
sake of discussion put the number four
there and that is what happened when we
proposed uh changing the final garbage
value there to that four but now I need
to do what the slide did for us sort of
magically on the screen I should now do
a couple of final things I should free
the original list which I've not done
yet CU I only called free earlier in
cases of error and that was just to be
safe I can now free the list and now if
I want to inform the computer that I
want list quote unquote my variable
called list to point at not the old
chunk like it originally did but the new
chunk I think I can just do this list
equals
TMP and again that's just saying that if
list is a pointer which it was cuz look
at the very top line here on line eight
on line six I declared list to be a
pointer uh to a chunk of memory temp
meanwhile is a separate pointer to a
chunk of memory so down here this line
33 is just a matter of my saying okay
now henceforth because I've already
freed the old chunk of memory my list
variable should Point not at this chunk
of three bytes but this chunk of four
bytes or really 12 in total now uh or
rather 16 now because we have four such
bytes questions now on this code the
point of which was quite simply to
demonstrate how we could Implement and
code this idea of Fairly correctly but
inefficiently allocating a new array of
sufficient size and then populating it
with a new fourth
value questions on what we've just done
here no
yeah
[Music]
good question at this point in the story
with line 33 do I not have two different
variables pointing at the same chunk of
memory short answer yes but here's where
the semantics are perhaps compelling
list is the variable that I intend to
use longer term and keep around in
memory and again assume that there's
even more code going on here that we
just didn't write yet so it's useful to
have that that variable temp was just
kind of a necessary evil because up here
it would not have been correct to do
this it would not have been correct to
say list on line 18 equals the new chunk
of memory because this would have
represented a memory leak if I pre uh
prematurely change temp to point not at
the old chunk but the new chunk at that
point no one's pointing at the old chunk
and so I've lost those three bites vren
for instance would yell at you for
having lost as many btes in memory so in
this case here I do leave this as temp
yes it's duplicative at this point but
it's it's not a huge deal if it was just
meant semantically to be a temporary
value but down here at the risk of one
more line of code I still want to to be
a good citizen free list and maybe just
for good measure return zero explicitly
but notice it's not doing it twice per
se on line 31 what am I freeing the
original address of list the three
integer version then I change what list
points at so it's pointing at a
completely different chunk of memory
this one of size four So eventually when
I'm all done using this memory for this
demonstration I still need to free list
but at this point in the story line 40
it's pointing at the new chunk of memory
which I similarly need to hand back to
the operating system by free
yeah when would temp equal null so let
me scroll back up slightly this is being
a good citizen and a good programmer
whenever it comes to using malok malok
can return null if the computer's out of
memory so this is maybe a much bigger
program you've got other things going on
in it and so you just don't have enough
memory available to be handed malok
needs to signal to you that there's some
error and so it will by convention per
the documentation per the manual pages
return null so this is just me being a
good citizen otherwise here's another
error that might cause your program to
crash with a segmentation fault if you
get back null but you assume that it's
good memory uh going to address zero AKA
null will crash your program
intentionally
[Music]
yeah correct if I were to change my
final line 40 here to be free temp this
would also work as well and here this is
really a matter of design it's a very
nitpicky thing we could probably debate
it but because at this point in the
story my main variable for remembering
where the list is is called list this is
sort of the more responsible way to do
it freeing the list just so that my
colleagues my ta doesn't sort of wonder
why are you freeing temporary ver memory
that you already freed like it just is a
semantic thing at this point but good
Instinct it would also work correct
maybe just not good design all right so
it turns out that this gets annoying
quickly as it did in the picture of
doing all of this duplication and even
though technically it's necessary to
copy those values if you need a newer
bigger chunk of memory
there is at least a function in C that
simplifies a lot of this for us and in
fact let me go ahead and do this instead
of using malok this second time on line
18 in addition to the first time I used
it on line six I'm actually going to try
and introduce another function called
realloc which as the name suggests tries
to reallocate memory for you and it
works a little differently from malok
realloc expects two arguments the first
one is what is the chunk of memory that
you want to try to grow or Shrink that
is reallocate to be a different size and
then you specify what size you would
want and indeed in this case I want four
times size of int and that will now give
me hopefully a new address of a chunk of
memory that's big enough to fit all four
numbers but what's wonderful about
realloc is that it will handle all of
the copying for me so in fact I'm going
to go down here I'm going to get rid of
all of this this extra for Loop and what
I'm simply going to do instead is this
once I can
trust after lines 18 through 23 that
rioc worked and it didn't return null
because I'm out of memory I can just say
okay just immediately remember that the
new list points at this new chunk of
memory instead and then I can still now
do this line but I can tweak the
semantics here and just say list bracket
3 the new Final a in uh um the new list
is for I don't need to free this here I
don't need to do this all I need now at
the bottom is the final for Loop to just
print out these values so in short even
though that was somewhat quick using
realloc just moves the entire copying
process that I implemented myself a
moment ago using a for Loop it just
moves it to realloc and lets it deal
with the copying for me it's no more
efficient but at least means uh I'm
writing less code which is more pleasant
and hopefully the people who wrote aloc
or realloc are smarter than me and they
just will introduce bugs with lower
probability
too all right that was a lot any
[Music]
questions good question why do you still
need to make list equal temp as I did on
line 24 so ideally I would do this
ideally I would just change this line 18
to be list that is to say call re or
actually even better ideally I would
just say realloc this list to be of this
new size but again things can go wrong
when allocating memory you need to check
a return value to see if it was
successful or not and so we need to use
a return value okay so let's not
introduce temp let's just use list but
here's where a memory leak might happen
in the off chance realloc fails and
doesn't have enough memory for your four
bytes therefore it returns by definition
null you can't overwrite the original
value of list with null
to then check it why because now who
remembers where the original Three byes
were if you prematurely change the value
of list you've lost you've uh leaked
memory in that sense and so that's why
let me undo this change I declare a
temporary pointer for the sole purpose
of making sure I can check the return
value and then once it's good now I'll
update the value of list so it's sort of
doing a Switcheroo by making sure first
that you have a new value to swap with
the old other question
on this code
yeah indeed realloc automatically frees
the previous memory for you and better
yet it's even smarter than that if you
get lucky and they happens to be space
right after your existing chunk of
memory so one two three garbage value
instead of one two three hello world
realloc won't even bother copying things
from old to new it will just say okay
I'm going to now reserve for you more
bites than you originally asked for so
it doesn't have to waste time doing that
copying and so in that sense this
version is now not only still correct
it's even better designed because we're
not wasting time with that for Loop we
might have to resort to it if there is
in fact hello world or something else in
the way but hopefully we'll get lucky
and save those steps other questions on
this this manipulation of code
here yeah in the
middle
what if you want to resize a
two-dimensional array so very similar in
Spirit uh whereby you can use the same
trickery let me wave my hand at that for
now just because I think that's going to
sort of significantly increase the
complexity but very same Primitives
ultimately a two-dimensional array is
essentially just a doubly long or
quadratically longer list of memory that
using square bracket notation is doing
some of that mental math for you but
it's fundamentally no different of
what's going on underneath the
hood all right so with that said and
that code under our belt even though
that's not going to be something you'll
frequently need to code yourself let's
propose now how we might go about
building some actual data structures
ourselves the new ingredient here being
this reality that if you want to resize
a chunk of memory so is to make room for
things we now have that ability memory
addresses and pointers just give us the
ability to like Point around at things
and move things around in memory but now
that we have malok and even realloc you
can imagine maybe rewinding and you
could Implement that stack that Q using
not an array per se because you have to
commit to an array size in advance but
if you implement your stack or your que
using a pointer and then malok and
realloc and maybe someone else writes
all that code for you perhaps now you
can imagine that okay now the stack can
grow or Shrink by using realloc
accordingly you don't have to preact pre
um preemptively say give me five bytes
or 50 or 500 or 5,000 you can say just
give me one initially and if I need more
I'll realloc realloc reloc and if you
keep popping things off the stack you
can realloc in the other direction and
ask for fewer and fewer bytes and the
operating system can take that memory
back as well so we now have this
building block let's see what we can do
with it so we've had a few pieces of
syntax in recent weeks all of which
we're going to combine now in just a
slightly more clever way so struct is
this keyword in C that lets us build our
own structure in memory like a
collection of two or three or more
variables like a person that we've seen
before the dot operator recall we've
used when you do have a struct like a a
person and you want to go inside of it
so like uh person. name or person.
number we did this a few weeks ago now
but the dot Operator just allows you to
go inside of a structure and get the
individual variables within and then the
star operator unfortunately has a lot of
uses now one was multiplication like my
God that was easy back in the day now
it's used to declare pointers it's also
used to dreference pointers so to make
one exist and then go to that address
unfortunately it's the same symbol for
all of those but it's all related but
with these three symbols it turns out
you're going to get one last one today
and my God it finally looks like the
concept it turns out there's a clever
way anytime you want to use the dot and
the star together that is to go
somewhere and go to an address and then
look inside of a structure you can
actually literally use an arrow symbol
on your keyboard it's not a single
keystroke it's a hyphen and then an open
angle bracket but at least it looks like
an arrow and we'll see indeed in code
today the things I was drawing
pictorially on the screen last time with
yellow arrows you can actually now
Express as well in code and so here we
have our next data structure called a
linked list and this is one of the most
useful powerful Concepts in C it's the
kind of thing that you can take for
granted in Java and Python and higher
level languages but today we'll see how
we or others can actually build these
things just using these same Primitives
so a linked list is going to allow us to
actually do what we you know used a foam
finger for last week allow us to link
together for instance these three values
maybe with that fourth value over there
and then if there's a fifth you know
maybe this other foam finger points even
farther overway to that fifth value the
key being that you can stitch together
fancier data structures without having
to like pick all of these up and find
new space you just have to at least
connect the dots somehow we just need to
somehow point from one to the other and
that's going to make things much more
efficient it would seem so how do we get
there so here's my computer's memory as
always suppose that I'm storing the
value one somewhere in there and it's at
ox123 address whatever and I'm storing
the number two somewhere else in memory
Ox 456 and number three at address Ox
789 this is not an array by definition
why even though it's the only three
things on the screen what makes this not
an array it's not contiguous so this
violates the definition of an array but
you know especially since they're
sequential it kind of looks to a human
like a list so it would be nice if there
were a data type called list and there
isn't in C there will be in Python but
you know what if I could somehow like
Stitch together these three values so I
can get from one to the next to the next
then I think we could achieve the idea
the concept of a list without this
really annoying constraint that they all
be contiguous as in an array so how do I
do that well at the end of the day I
only have memory at my disposal right
there's no more training wheels to take
off here this is what we've got
underneath the hood of a computer so if
all I have is memory I think the
solution to this problem of stitching
together those values in a list must be
to spend a bit more memory that's
literally the only resource we have
right now so let me propose that if we
want to create a list conceptually out
of three values that are in random
although pictorially pretty positions in
memory let me just add a little bit more
memory to the picture so in addition to
storing the one I'm going to leave my
space myself some room a little scratch
pad if you will to use some other bits
as well same for the two same for the
three and you can perhaps see where this
is going based on last week if I want to
somehow connect the one to the two any
instincts as to what I should write in
this box here that would lead me
effectively from one to the two
what could go here
yeah we could store the address of Two
And so specifically what would you have
me write
here perfect ideally I would just put in
this box another integer one that
happens to be represented in heximal but
that's just a base system it's just a
human thing for us to look at I'm going
to put the value Ox 456 here so let me
go ahead and reveal that Ox 456 goes
there you can perhaps see further where
this is going well if I want to get from
the two to the three I think I need to
put below the two the address of the
three which gives me Ox 789 now if three
is the end of the list I don't want to
let it be some garbage value because
that would imply that it who knows where
it's pointing I need some definitive
value and just what would your instincts
be if I want to make clear with some
special Sentinel value that the buck
stops here what do I put what my my
options be yeah so null not n per se but
n l which was the new keyword we
introduced last week which just
represents an empty pointer if you will
technically the address o x0 so
literally the zero address and what
humans did years ago they just decided
you know what nothing should ever live
at address zero in memory we're just
going to reserve that one special bite
to be a special signal a sentinel value
such that if you ever see a zero address
in a pointer it just means it's it's
invalid it does not exist now now we
write that though a little more
pleasantly for the eyes as just n l in
all caps and that's a key word in C as
well but of course last week I claimed
that who cares where things are in
memory and honestly like this quickly
gets tedious even worrying about these
values so let me abstract this away and
propose that if we want to remember
where all of these numbers are in memory
let's give oursel one final piece of
memory that just allows us to start the
whole process let me allocate on the
left hand side here not room for a
number like 1 two 3 just room for a
pointer that henceforth I think I'll
call list by convention and then store
in that one additional pointer a value
that just kickstarts the whole process
this is the sort of treasure map if you
will that you get handed and this has
the address of the very first actual
node in memory now technically we could
just start with this but it turns out
we'll see it's just a little cleaner to
use a simple single pointer that leads
to the things you care about as opposed
to just starting with the first element
why well if you ever want to get rid of
this element it'd be nice if you could
at least still hang on to an empty sheet
of paper that indicates that the list is
empty would be one argument for that so
again who cares about these addresses
now now with the wave of the hand let's
just abstract it away and there are our
pointers each of those addresses in the
rec uh the squares at the bottom are
simply pointing to the next element in
the list the jargon to introduce here
would be that now that we have these
integers 1 2 3 but they're in these like
wrappers if you will these structures
that have metadata that is additional
data that is related to but not the data
you actually care about this is data
this is metadata this thing here
rectangularly we'll call a node n o and
it's just a term of art that means it's
like a container in code for storing
some
values this then is a linked list and
this then is the sort of graphical
incarnation of like one node pointing to
the other in this case case they happen
to be by chance and by design of this
desk contiguous initially but there's no
requirement that they be such the one
could be over there the two over there
the three over there I would just need
more foam fingers to point at one to the
next questions on this concept of a
linked
list yeah and
[Music]
back can you say that
again a good question do traditional
arrays start with a pointer that's
outside of the structure short answer no
arrays are special in C and certain
other languages and the name of an array
is technically a symbol if you will that
the computer the program knows maps to a
specific location in memory it's just a
label a synonym for a memory address it
does not take up space so to be clear
the name of an array does not take up
space like that extra Square on the left
but you do need that extra Square on the
left when implementing a link list so
that you can determine if the list is of
size zero there's nothing being pointed
at or size three in this case we're sort
of taking on more responsibility
ourselves
yeah how do you point to the next
element can you
[Music]
elaborate ah good question if each of
these elements is pointing to the next
how is three point to the others short
answer it doesn't at least in this
design we have more technically what's
called a singly linked list and as the
arrows imply it only goes in One
Direction so if you somehow find incode
maybe a for Loop maybe a while loop
somehow you're sort of encode over here
you have no way in code to go backwards
unless we changed this to a doubly link
list where I add another box that lets
me have arrows in both directions or
maybe I just kind of make it uh uh
circular and I connect the three back to
the one which you can totally do but
that tends to you know make life harder
because now you have to figure out when
you're stuck in a loop in your data
structure but it's doable as well but as
is it's a dead end by Design other
questions on this design
here all right well how might we
implement this structure in code well
let me just connect the dots to
something like we've seen before here
like this is how a couple of weeks ago
we introduced the notion of a a person
and we claimed a person might have a
name and a number last week of course we
took off some of these training wheels
and a string is really technically a
Char star in both cases but really
there's no conceptual difference beyond
that but let's use this same Paradigm to
implement a node as I described it in
that picture so let me get rid of the
name and the number because that's
related only to a person and let me
rename this structure for discussion
sake to node that then invites the
question well what needs to go inside of
a node well minimally an
integer but this is now where we need to
think a little harder just conceptually
even if you have no idea how to type it
at the keyboard what else needs to be
part of a node based on these
rectangular pictures that we've
drawn what more do we need
yeah yeah we need a pointer to another
node so if I don't know how to implement
this yet you know it could be something
like you know pointer to another node
how do I do that well you know what but
it turns out you would ideally say this
if you know that the next node is itself
a node by definition well anytime we've
needed a pointer we just use the data
type and a star and I'm going to
arbitrarily but I think reasonably call
this second square at the bottom of
those rectangles next as the name of my
attribute here but node star just
connotes that the next variable is going
to be not a node per se but the address
of a node and that's exactly what we did
you had me put Ox 456 Ox 789 in that box
which is the address of another node so
the way we would Express this in code
would be node star next but we could
call the variable anything we want now
this is a bit of a white lie but we'll
fix this right now this code won't
actually compile C takes you pretty
literally recall and if you use some
term at the top of your file that you
don't Define until later in your file
you're going to see some error message
right we've seen this when I've messed
up and forgot to include the function
prototypes at the top of my code this is
related in spirit I seem here on my 1
two 3 fourth line of code I'm trying to
use this new term of art that I invented
here in my code called node even though
it's a CS term as well but nowhere Above
This it would seem did I even Define
what a node is it's not a data type and
C every computer scientist know what a
node is but it doesn't come for free
with the language so I need to do
something else like I need this word
here to come first so that I can use it
here and so we have this sort of Catch
22 like how can a structure be
self-referential that is point to
another version of itself if the word
doesn't yet exist so the solution to
this in C which we didn't need for a
person because there was no notion of
listing connecting as a list we need one
more keyword here that we didn't need
for a person and we reuse that keyword
here so kind of an annoying detail but
if we preemptively call this whole thing
struct node you can now refer to the
thing on the inside as a struct node
star but then you can shorten the name
of the whole thing from struct node to
just node sort of an annoying sequence
of steps but in short anytime you're
building a node a linked list in memory
this is just the Paradigm you use type
def struct the name of the thing you
want to Define like node you use that
name on the inside if you want to point
from one to another and then you can
shorten it down here to just be called
node questions then on this code
here questions on what we just did well
if I rewind just a moment to that final
picture what would be the upside to be
clear of having jumped through these
hoops and added this complexity if you
will what problem did we just solve by
linking together these three values to
be clear
[Music]
yeah making lists that
are that are not contiguous if you will
so making lists that are not contiguous
in memory the upside of which is that if
I want to add the number four to this
list it looks like I could choose from
any chunks of available memory on the
screen I just need to sort of point from
the end of the current list to wherever
that other one is in memory what I don't
need to do to be clear is copy the One
the two or the three everything can just
stay put which means TimeWise I can do
this much more quickly it would seem
without copying things again and again
and even without using realloc to let it
do all of the copying potentially for me
all right but as we'll start seeing even
more in the coming weeks every time we
benefit and solve some problem we pay a
price there's a tradeoff what is a
downside as you might perceive now of
using a linked list instead of an array
yeah as much memory yeah I mean we use
twice as much memory because now in
addition to storing the integers one two
three I also need to store a pointer for
each of those and honestly even this
picture is a bit of uh simplification
technically in most systems today each
int would be four bytes technically
today most pointers though would be
eight bytes I just didn't want to draw
this weird shape on the board where the
bottom square is even bigger than the
top square but technically we're using
even more than twice as much space for
these pointers so there's that trade-off
now thankfully decades after SE was
invented memory is generally much
cheaper nowadays and so it's okay to
sort of spend more of it if you need to
and it depends on what you want to
optimize for but that's absolutely here
a downside what's another downside of
having transitioned to in a uh link list
you can't index into it now I haven't
even tried in code but when you have a
linked list you can no longer use square
bracket notation because why well square
bracket notation just assumes the
contiguousness of memory location zero
is here location one is literally one to
the right location two is literally one
to the right one to the right these
things even though I've drawn it from
right to left to just keep things pretty
there are gaps here and this is just my
interpretation of this these gaps could
be big they could be narrow they could
be down here up here they could be
anywhere so long as we're linking things
together in this list the computer can't
just use bracket zero bracket 1 bracket
two anymore because it can't do simple
arithmetic and jump to like the middle
and now here's perhaps the worst price
we've paid if you don't have square
bracket notation or really you don't
have
contiguousness what algorithm did we
just sacrifice for this
dynamism if you rewind even back to week
zero and we gave it a name in week
three what algorithm can we not use now
if we can't assume that the memory is
back to back to back to
back binary search why because binary
search just like the phone book back in
the first week requires being able to
arithmetically jump right to the middle
right take the total length of it divide
by two and boom you're right there in
the Middle with some simple arithmetic
here they might be laid out again with
these big or small gaps there's no
simple math I can do to just jump
immediately to the one in the middle and
in fact again if this TV were bigger the
two could technically be in memory be
way down here or even way over here the
foam finger could be pointing in any
number of directions depending on where
malok put the thing there's just no way
to do binary search and so it would seem
that we've paid another price indeed in
terms of it performance we're now
talking about linear time again so
that's a regression now that's also a
lot things like feels like a good time
for some muffins and fruit out in the
lobby and when we come back we'll try to
solve the problem we just created so see
you in 10 so we are back and let's see
if we can't now take some of these
higher level concepts of like stitching
together these nodes in memory and
translate it to some actual code but
we'll do it step by step first before I
actually start writing it in vs code so
if Carter you wouldn't mind helping me
step through with some visuals let me
propose that line by line we solve some
of the problems that we've just created
for ourselves in building this thing in
memory so let's go ahead and first
consider how we could build a length
list containing the numbers indeed one
then two then three and let's translate
each of those steps to code and then
we'll put it all together into something
that actually runs so how about first
step here will just be this to declare a
pointer called list that's initially has
no value at least at this point in the
story list is the name of the variable
node star just means that this is
essentially going to be our little
square over here that points to the
beginning of the list of course it's
ideal If It ultimately has a value
because when we initially I'll call this
line of code it just gives us indeed
that square over here on the left but
it's got a garbage value because there's
no equal sign on the other side there so
let's propose that we do one more step
here and actually initialize it to null
so that if only we know that it's not
garbage it at least has some known value
and null is a good way of signifying
that at this point in the story The List
is empty indeed null indicates there's
no nodes in the list so that picture
would now look like this whereby let's
just draw instead of writing null
everywhere I'll just leave the squares
blank when it's not a garbage value per
se it's literally Ox Z or null all right
so that's it for building a link list of
size zero like we're sort of done then
but we want to now add a one and then a
two then a three so next step here might
be this if I want to allocate the first
of my rectangles on our previous picture
I'm going to call malok and I'm going to
ask for enough memory to fit a whole
node now technically I think that's
going to be like four bytes for the int
and eight bytes for the pointer even
though I did not draw it to scale on the
board so that's technically going to be
what 12 bytes but again size of node
just figures out how many bytes I
actually need dynamically that's going
to return to me the address of that
chunk of memory which apparently I'm
going to store inside of a temporary
variable called n for short for node but
let's see what this does pictorially so
when this line of code is executed I
first get on the left that variable n
it's got a garbage value by default
because I haven't executed the whole
thing from right to left meanwhile on
the right hand side of the expression
I've got now a node somewhere in memory
it happened to be free here this is
where malok put it for me but it does
have two garbage values initially but
because it's a node per my type def
earlier every node I proposed is going
to have a number and a next pointer so
we can see those labeled here but
they've got two garbage values initially
but all I care about initially is that
ultimately n is pointing at that chunk
of code so initially if we could back up
two
steps we have two steps so we have initi
one step forward we have this line of
code gives us this variable here which
has garbage when this side of the
expression is executed that allocates
the memory and then when we copy from
right to left the address of that chunk
of memory that's what gives us
conceptually this arrow and the garbage
goes away because it's a valid pointer
now of course there's still two garbage
values there because we haven't set this
node to store a number like the number
one so let's go ahead and execute one
other line of code like this which while
cryptic looking is just an application
of ideas we've seen in week four and
prior star N means to start at this
variable and go there Follow the arrow
is what the star or the D reference
operator does for us and then the dot
operator recall when we first introduce
structs like for a person struct allows
us to go at the number field or the next
field so if I do star n and then in
parentheses to make sure order of
operations is preserved do number and
then assign it the actual number one
which puts the one in the top of that
rectangle now admittedly this syntax is
not very user friendly it's annoying to
remember you have to the parentheses so
there's another Syntax for this whenever
you're doing two things like this in
code dereferencing a pointer that is
going to an address and then further
using the dot notation to go inside of
the structure you find that wonderfully
C gives us this syntax whereby you can
just change the star and the parentheses
and the dot to just be an arrow and
again it's not a single character on
your keyboard it's a hyphen and then an
open angle bracket but I kind of like
the semantics of this because this code
now pretty much matches the picture n
arrow leads you to the value that you
want to access or ultimately change in
this way there's one step though we've
forgotten of course which is that we
can't leave this garbage value here
because the garbage value is some
unknown value that effectively is
pointing who knows where and we don't
want to accidentally misinterpret that
garbage value as being a valid address
and risk going there so of course what
value should we put here instead our old
friend null just to signify that this is
indeed the end of the list and we could
do that with a line of code like this
and again we'll canote as much by just
leaving that empty box blank so now we
have a list of size one let's go ahead
and add the second number to it as with
these lines here list equals n allows us
to remember that indeed we have this
list here so if we can step one step
forward here's what the picture now
looks like and technically let's go one
step further here this is now really
what's going on in memory once my list
of size exists my main variable called
list is pointing at exactly that first
node at this point in the story I don't
need to know or care about the temporary
variable that I called n even though it
might very well still be there but
indeed this now represents that link
list let's now indeed add the number two
so with the same line of code as before
I'm going to allocate another node size
of node ideally I would be checking for
null here but we're doing the juicy
Parts only on the slides let's now go
ahead and depict that so what happens
with this this brings back our n pointer
which might have been there the whole
time but we're doing this step by step
it's a garbage value though because we
haven't yet copied from right to left
Malo of course gives us a second chunk
of memory which maybe ends up there with
two garbage values by default I've
omitted the labels now just because
they're still going to be number and
next respectively once we copy from
right to left the garbage value indeed
becomes an arrow Oscar disappears
because it's now indeed a valid pointer
pointing here now the values themselves
number and next are invalid garbage
values so here is where we can now start
using our new syntax like the arrow
notation or the star and the dot if you
prefer and we can change the value of n
Follow the arrow to number and that
becomes two similarly we can do this
again and set n arrow next so start at n
Follow the arrow access the next field
and set that equal to null now we're not
quite done yet because we haven't
actually linked things together so
here's now where things get interesting
how do I combine these two well let me
me propose this let me propose on our
next line here we actually update for
Now list equal to n that is to say
whatever address this is whatever it's
pointing at change list to be the same
address that is point at the same thing
so if n is pointing here let's change
list to point here and go ahead and do
that Carter if you could I don't like
this can you go one further step this is
bad what is wrong about my sequence of
operations here where I updated list to
point my new
node
yeah yeah we lost the pointer to the
other node so I don't even care about
the ordering 21 or one two the bigger
problem now as the lack of arrows over
there suggests is that I have a memory
leak I have orphaned my original node in
the sense that nothing is pointing at it
anymore now absolutely I could fix this
by adding some temporary variables I
could add it to the mix but at this
point in the story I have not done any
such uh recollection thereof so let me
back this up and let's go forward in the
slides this is where we left off a
moment ago I think I need to take into
account order of operations and I'm
going to keep this simple I'm not going
to care about the order of the numbers
for now I'm fine with a list that is two
and then one so with that said let me go
ahead and update I think this box here
to point at my original node so let's
see how we can do this in code okay n
arrow next so n arrow next should equal
the current list and this is a little
weird again but recall what list is list
is this pointer here that just contains
the address of the original address of
the list or equivalently it contains
this Arrow whatever it's pointing at so
what this means in this line of code n
bracket next means start at n Follow the
arrow access the next pointer and set it
equal to whatever list equals so if list
is pointing here then next should point
there as well this I think is safe
because now we have redundancy now we've
got two pointers pointing at the
original list and now I think we can do
another step whereby we update list to
equal n same line of code before that
got us into trouble but I'm doing it
second now instead of first when I
execute list equals n this now sets list
equal to the same thing that n equals
and so now I have successfully inserted
my new node containing two into the list
and in fact if we advance one more we
can just clear up the Clutter assume
that the temporary variable is gone from
the story now we have a linked list
where admittedly ordering is wrong it's
21 instead of one two but at least it's
linked correctly and I didn't orphan or
leak any
memory questions on this sequence of
steps
here yeah in
[Music]
back yeah spot on so this would fall
under that category of a stack if you
will although I've not called it that by
name because I just pushed the number
two onto this data structure if you will
and indeed it ended up at the beginning
of the list instead of the end and so
here's where we see a distinction
between an abstract data structure which
is where we began a stack is a thing
like the pile of sweaters that just has
push and pop properties and lifo access
like uh last in first out how do you
implement something like that in memory
well it would seem that you could
implement the notion of a stack here not
for sweaters but for numbers using a
linked list so long as you implement
insertion AKA pushing by prepending new
values to the list by prepending again
and again and if Carter you don't mind
hitting the keyboard one more time if I
wanted to add the number three now you
would could imagine prepending it to the
list why well honestly especially as
this list gets longer and longer I kind
of like the appeal of prepending these
elements why because even if this list
gets crazy long and way way out here you
didn't notice me following all of the
arrows earlier to do the insert if I
want to insert a fourth number a fifth
number a sixth number all I have to do
is like insert it here if you will point
it at the original uh start of the list
then update this pointer and done and I
would say that's like two steps give or
take it's not going to be end steps as
it would be if I had to upend the new
nodes to the end of the list now of
course we've sacrificed ordering of
these numbers they're literally in the
opposite order or whatever order they
were inserted in but that might very
well be okay depending on the goal at
hand all right thank you to Carter for
stepping through this what if now we
wanted to translate this oh sure thank
you it's all for you none for me in this
example so here we have perhaps a way of
translating this now to some actual code
and this will be the last of like the
sort of intense code here just to give
you a sense of how we can translate this
idea now to actual step so this is list.
C and VSS code here let me go ahead and
make a couple of changes up top let me
go ahead and how about uh declaring a
node using typ def uh struct node using
our new framing as before I'm going to
give every node a number as I proposed
and every node a pointer to the next
element which is going to be implemented
just as before and I'm going to simplify
the whole name as just node so all of
that is is the exact same type depth
that we proposed earlier now let me go
ahead and get rid of all of this code
which we wrote earlier and recall that
this was the most recent version that
was not a linked list this was just in
Array that we allocated and then
reallocated so this is sort of the old
way of doing things but it was
inefficient because we might have to
lean on a for Loop or lean on realloc to
copy everything around we're now going
to reimplement the notion of a list as
an actual linked list not as an array so
my main function now might do something
like this and I'm going to really just
copy the lines of code that we just
stepped through on the board so let me
give myself a uh special variable called
list that's going to be initialized to
null and this is just my pointer the
square on the left hand side of the
screen that represents the start of the
list and if it's null it means the list
is empty so done I'm done implementing a
linked list of size zero well now how do
I want to run this code well let me
propose for the sake of discussion that
this version of the program will take
command line arguments so I want to be
able to do something like this I want to
run this program ultimately and type in
three command line arguments like this 1
2 3 and I want my program in a couple
minutes to allocate one two three nodes
and Stitch them together just like the
visualization on the board uh I could
use get int but it's just going to be
faster if we use command line arguments
so again I'm just borrowing some
Concepts from week two but none of
that's possible yet until I change my
code here so let's do this in argc uh
string uh argv but you know what we know
that strings are not actually a thing
anymore so I can change my command line
argument definition to be what it really
is it's really charar but it's the exact
same thing as in week two just strings
are no more at least without the
training wheels on anymore like last
week and now let me do this uh for in I
equal 1 uh I is less than ARG C i++ so
what I'm doing with this Loop is I just
want to iterate over the command line
argument so I have one number at a time
from The Prompt um what else do I want
to do here uh well let's go ahead and
how about do this um let's get
a number so in number equals arv braet I
so a couple of notes Here one I'm
starting my for loop at one instead of
zero but I'm going up to RC RC is
argument count how many words are at the
prompt why am I starting at one instead
of zero though given my
goal why am I starting at one
yeah yeah so the first value in RV is is
actually the name of the program that's
obviously not a number so I want the
second value so I'm going to start
iterating over those command line
arguments at I equals 1 so that's all I
just want to get the actual numbers at
the prompt um unfortunately argv bracket
I is a string AKA Char star that is not
an INT so this line of code won't work
but can anyone think back to like week
two where we had a function for
converting strings to
integers anyone yeah so a to I is a
function that converts asky to an
integer assuming what you give it as an
argument looks like a number like one or
two or three so let me fix this let me
actually do the conversion if I were
really being careful I would error check
this make sure that there's no digits
just like you might have in problem set
two but for today's purposes I'm just
going to assume the honor System that
the user me is going to run the program
correctly all right so now that I have a
variable containing the number from the
command line let's just allocate a node
for it so let me do node star n just
like we did in the visualization and
let's malok enough space for the size of
one such node here I now need to just be
super safe so if n equals equals null
like if I'm out of memory you know what
let me go ahead and just immediately
return one here otherwise if that's not
the case let me go ahead and update the
number field of this new node which it
line 24 does exist because it did not
return null so I did not exit early with
return and let me just store whatever
number that human typed in first so the
return value of a to I which per line 17
is in my variable called number and then
let me go ahead and just prepend this to
the list let me go ahead and say that um
this next field first has a known value
null just so that we get rid of that
second garbage value and let me go ahead
and now prepend it to the list so if I
want to prepend it that means this new
node must have a next field field that
points to the current beginning of the
list and again the goal here is to preen
Preen Preen so whatever the current list
is let's change it so that this new node
points to that existing list and now
step two as before was to update the
actual list to point at this node so
recall in red on the screen before I
screwed up originally and I only did
this line by moving the pointer too
early if you will but I fixed that once
Carter helped me rewind and we got rid
of the red line which indicated error
and I just do n arrow next to change the
next field of this new node to point to
the existing list so I'm not orphaning
anything all right at this point in the
story I think my code is
correct not batting very well though
today but I think my code is correct but
the program doesn't do anything
interesting so it would be nice to kind
of now iterate over this link list in
memory whatever its order is and print
things out well how do we do that well
it turns out if you want to iterate over
a linked List the general Paradigm is to
do something like this to define a
temporary variable I could call it temp
but another convention that you might as
well see is called pointer PTR for short
but you can call it anything you want
and you can have a temporary variable
first point at the first node in the
list and then in some kind of loop like
a while loop you point it at the second
node in the list and then you keep
iterating you point it at the last node
in the list and then eventually you
iterate too far effectively pointing at
null at which point your while loop can
presumably terminate so how do I
Implement that idea of allocating a
temporary pointer that just points at
each node in the list and lets me print
out ultimately each of those numbers
well let's go back to my code here and
let me do this let me go ahead and
declare this temporary pointer which is
going to be a node star also why because
it's the address of a node the first the
second the third and I'm going to set
that equal to whatever the beginning of
the list is so that is going to be
equivalent to this version of the
picture here where pointer is just
temporarily pointing at the first node
in the list it's not pointing at list
per se it's pointing at the first node
in the list which list is also pointing
at itself all right once I've done this
I think I can translate this to code
that's a little new but it's
conceptually familiar perhaps now while
that pointer does not equal null so
while I have a valid pointer like my
finger or that arrow is pointing at an
actual node in memory well let me go
ahead and print it out so let me print
out with percent I back sln whatever is
in the current node at the number field
within and again this is going to have
the effect hopefully of first printing
the three and I think I just need to Now
update the pointer so that on the next
iteration it's pointing at the next
value so if this is where the story is
how do I update pointer to point at the
second element of the list well I want
pointer to point at the two and I want
pointer to eventually point at the three
well how do I do that well the way in
code I can follow these arrows is as
follows if I currently have pointer
pointing at this node but I want to
point it at the next node I can borrow
this pointer here so whatever this
address is in the first node aka the
next field I can copy that into pointer
because then pointer will point at
whatever this is pointing at by just
setting one equal to the other so once
I've done that the picture will
become this and how do I translate that
to code it while new syntax is
surprisingly straightforward all I need
do is say pointer after printing it
equals whatever pointer currently is but
grab its next field
instead and this is a very common
Paradigm when iterating over a link list
and you're using some temporary variable
like pointer you can simply set pointer
equal to pointer next and what that
means here is as follows if this is
pointer pointing from here down to here
pointer next is Follow the arrow grab
the next field so if you set pointer
equal to this thing that's the same
thing as pointing this at this same box
and indeed if I advance to the next
slide even though the arrows are
technically pointing at different parts
of the rectangles that's just for
graphic sake pointer is now pointing at
the second node and when I do this again
on my next iteration it points at this
and then this last step notice when I
keep doing pointer equals pointer next
this will become eventually this value
but what's this value in this link list
it's null technically so this Arrow will
eventually take on this value when I set
pointer equal to pointer next and at
that point PTR my temporary pointer is
going to be null so it might as well
look like this pictorially and what does
that mean for my Loop once pointer is
null because you've walked off the end
of the length list what's going to be
true of this Loop here started in line
32 any OB observations
here what's going to be true what will
happen now as soon as we hit the end of
the list yeah
sorry the loop is going to break out why
because line 32 which is constantly
asking well pointer does not equal null
well if pointer finally equals null
three steps later the four the while
loop is now done and so what I can do at
the end of this program once I've
printed out those values well first
let's go ahead and open my terminal
window let's make list okay a compile
do/ list and let me try the same values
one and two and three that's going to
again allocate one node two node three
nodes by prepending prepending
prepending each of those values and it's
then going to iterate over them from
left to right and so when I hit enter
now what should I see on the screen if
my code is
correct what will I see feel fre to just
call it
out 321 because I've prepended
presumably and here we go I indeed see
321 so the list is is backwards but all
of the elements are there now
technically if I ran valgrind on this
valgren would not be happy because I
have never freed any of my memory so I
should probably now have a second Loop
here that does something like this let
me again set pointer equal to list I
don't need to redeclare it because I've
already created this thing on line 31 I
just want to reset it to be the
beginning of the list again and now I
can do the same kind of thing while PTR
not equals null go ahead and do this
well I don't want to just do free
pointer and then do pointer gets pointer
next y my goal is to free all of my
memory but I think this is going to get
me in trouble pointer equals list just
gives me a temporary pointer that points
at the three and then eventually the two
and then the one how well while pointer
not equal null I'm freeing the pointer
so this is like saying to Malo free that
node free that node free that node but
what's the problem with what I've just
done
here this code is technically Bugg
[Music]
yeah exactly after you call free on
pointer You Are by social contract with
c not allowed to touch pointer anymore
it is invalid now it's still going to be
a number it's still going to be a
pattern of bits but it's invalid and
you'll very often get a segmentation
fault if you tempt fate in that way so I
can't free the pointer and then use it
literally the next line the solution
here kind of like our swapping of the
liquids last time was to maybe just have
a temporary variable so I can do a
Switcheroo and so a common way to solve
this problem to get the order of
operations right would be to do
something like this give yourself a
temporary pointer like node star next
set it equal to the place you want to go
next so one step ahead now you can free
pointer and then you can update pointer
to be that next value so essentially you
need need like two hands now you create
on line 41 another pointer that if this
is pointing at the first Noe the three
your new pointer is pointing at the two
temporarily so now you can tell malok
via free release this memory but I
haven't forgotten where I want to go
next and so I can now continue on so a
common Paradigm for just iterating over
these nodes and then freeing them a
couple of observations strictly speaking
I could have Consolidated this I don't
need two Loops to print the nodes and
then free the nodes I could do that all
at once but let's assume that there's
other stuff of interest in my program
and I don't want to just immediately
free it there's one other bug that I
should probably address here there is
still a potential memory leak up here
and this one is super subtle the valind
would help you find it notice that in
this Loop here when I'm calling malok
this line of code is fine if the first
line of malok fails and returns null
because I immediately return and I'm
done but what if the second call but not
the first or the third call but not the
first or second fail this line of code
has me returning immediately you really
need to to do some garbage collection so
to speak whereby you really need to go
in and free any nodes that you did
allocate successfully earlier honestly
that's going to be a pin in the neck we
won't do that here but probably what I'd
want to do is write a function called
free list or something like that and
call that function to free any nodes I
had previously created so it's not quite
at the finish line but the building
blocks are indeed here questions on this
code and I think it's safe for me to
promise that it won't escalate further
from
that questions on
[Music]
this no well let me show you one
alternative that you might prefer and
I'm pretty sure this isn't an escalation
it's just an alternative formulation
another way you can iterate over nodes
in a list could be this instead of a
while loop for instance let me actually
show you one other piece of syntax here
you could technically use a for Loop you
could give yourself a node pointer here
that initialized is initialized to the
list you can then check in your for Loop
that it's not equal to null and then you
can do your update as usual like this
either of these are equivalent even
though this one I suspect looks scarier
it's doing the exact same thing in one
line instead of two but there's no
reason we can't use four Loops instead
of while Loops to achieve the same idea
but I'll leave these two as
demonstrations of one approach or the
other but that's just like in week one
four Loops while Loops whatever looks
simpler to you even though admittedly
neither of these probably looks super
clean all right so let's take the back
to things more conceptual here up until
now we've been inserting elements into
this link list by prepending them let's
consider what the running time then is
of these operations so if I've got a
link list of size three or size N More
generally time has passed and I've added
a lot of things to it what's going to be
the running time for instance of
searching a linked list for some value
and I'll tell you already it's not login
because again binary search is off the
table as per before break so what might
the running time be of searching a
linked list for some value like two or
three or 1 or
50 what might the running time
be o of I heard it over here o of n and
y who was that oh in the middle here why
o of
[Music]
n exactly you're going to have to go
through every item in the list starting
from the left from the beginning which
is how we've been drawing things and
connecting the dots and in the worst
case the element might very well be at
the very end so it's going to be Big O
of n what about insertion how many steps
in terms of Big O notation has it been
taking me to insert elements into the
link list using this prepended
design yeah so it's technically constant
time Big O of one and again one is just
representative of any constant it could
technically be two steps or three steps
or even 10 steps or 100 steps but if
it's always finite and fixed then indeed
you can say it's in Big O of one now why
is that well over again no matter how
long this list gets so long as there's
memory available for me I can just kind
of uh create a little splice at the
beginning of the list to put in the new
node update the original list and I'm on
my way and it keeps getting longer even
though it might not be spread out in
memory so big O of one is possible with
these link lists if I indeed Preen
things of course if I Preen things
everything's going to get out of order
potentially and we're going to have
maybe the stack property instead of a q
property so we might want to do things
slightly differently so instead of doing
this
whereby we kept prepending prepending
prepending suppose we append to the end
of the list instead so if we now insert
the one the two and the three as we
might want to for a q to maintain that
fairness property we might start with an
empty list we might add the one we might
append the two append the three and so
it just is sort of laid out differently
in memory and again if I can come to you
in the middle what's the running time of
search again when the link list uses
this append
implementation yeah still Big O of n
because in the worst case you're going
to have to go through the whole list
just to find it and notice it doesn't
matter if you have an intuition now that
the bigger numbers might very well be at
the end you have no way to jump to the
end you have no way to jump to the
middle or do anything resembling binary
search every search has to start from
the left and follow the arrows again and
again all right so I don't think we've
done any better there and in fact what
is insertions running time now in Big O
when we're appending to the list in this
way as we might to implement a Q instead
of a stack what's the running time of
inserting a new
value Big O
of so not Big O of one in this case but
Big O of n because if I'm appending by
definition I have to start here and
Traverse the whole thing looking for the
end now this is a bit of an
overstatement right you could obviously
optimize this slightly by maybe adding
another variable that always points to
the last element sort of a cheat sheet a
shortcut that gets you all the way to to
the end that's totally fine it's not
doesn't really fit the traditional
definition of a singly linked list but
there's absolutely smart engineering
solutions to these kinds of problems but
as designed it would indeed be Big O of
end to insert to if you've got to go all
the way to the end and you're not using
a little extra memory to get yourself
there quickly well what if we want to
take things one last step and not just a
pen blindly because even though I
inserted one two three if I inserted
them in random order they would end up
in random order what if you want to
maintain a sorted list from smallest to
largest well then you might want to
insert numbers like this starting from
an empty list we might have a two then
we might try inserting a one but we want
to keep it sorted so now we're going to
prepend in our code but then you might
want to insert a four so you would
append the four because you're probably
going to look for the right spot to
insert it then we're going to insert a
three and this one's getting a little
annoying because now you have to like
iterate over the list look for the right
spot and then do a little smarter of a
splice but it's possible but you don't
want to Orphan the four for instance and
then ultimately we get back to this
question what would the performance be
of your linked list if you're trying to
maintain sorted order well search I
think is going to be Big O of n for the
same reasons as before what about
insertion big go of what for inserting
into a sorted linked
list yeah in the worst
case yeah it's still Big O ofen so it's
no worse than but it's not really any
better than a pending but we gain the
additional property of maintaining a
sorted list which might very well be
useful if you're sorting your contacts
in your phone or something like that
where it just maintain makes sense to
maintain sorted order now in the code
for online today if you take a look at
some of the final versions of code like
list 6. C and list 5.c as we'll post on
the website you can actually see code
that will solve all three of these
problems the Preen version that we wrote
live the appen version which we talk
through as well as this sorted order one
but I think I'll avoid showing it live
just because I do think that starts to
escalate quickly but I think we have
enough of a building block if we're
comfortable with prepending to at least
solve some real world problems with
these link
lists questions then on link list which
we'll now leave behind on their own but
now use this technique to solve fancier
problems but much less
code questions on linked list all right
so to C recap we've kind of taken a s
side step with link list like we have
this dynamism now where we can grow and
Shrink our chunks of memory without over
allocating or accidentally
underallocation as in the world of an
array we don't have to worry about
copying values endlessly because once
you allocate the node it can just stay
wherever it is in memory and you can
just maintain uh you can just Stitch it
together somehow but unfortunately we've
sacrificed what we started the class
with in week zero which was like binary
search divide and conquer which was like
gave us that log and running time which
was really compelling if you think back
to the demonstrations and the the
visuals can we get the best of both
worlds can we get the sort of uh speed
of binary search something logarithmic
but the dynamism of something like a
link list well we can actually I think
if we start to think not in a single
Dimension just the x-axis if you will
but two Dimensions such that our data
structures can maybe now have width and
height if you will and so a tree is
perhaps the right term here much like a
family tree if you have sort of your
elders up here in the tree and then the
branches below them for their children
and grandchildren and the like that's
actually what a computer scientist means
when they talk about trees not a tree
that grows up like this but really one
that typically is depicted growing down
although this is just an artist's
depiction no matter what but there are
certain types of trees in the world
called binary search trees that are
structured on paper and in visually like
a uh family tree but they have a special
property that lends themselves to
exactly that feature binary search so
for instance here is an array back from
week two and I've sorted a whole bunch
of numbers here in from 1 to seven we
know we can do binary search on this
structure if it's implemented as an
array but what feature do arrays to be
clear not have that link lists
do today's kind of a seesaw like what
did we just gain by adding link list
that arrays do not
allow
yeah
yeah you can insert more elements
without having to copy or moving
everything else around like right now in
this single Dimension if these values to
the left and or right are already used
then you have to move everything and
that's where we started today's story so
arrays kind of paint you into a corner
because you have to by definition decide
in advance how big they are well
couldn't we have some kind of array that
can still grow but still is contiguous
so we can do binary search in some way
well yes if we sort of rethink how we
Implement binary search Let Me propose
that this I've chosen these seven
elements in the array much like the
lockers from uh week two to be ordered
from smallest to largest I've
highlighted now in yellow the middle
elements here and if we were telling the
story of week two going left or going
right let me highlight in red the middle
elements of the left half and the right
half and then let me further highlight
in green the other elements in between
those and there's a pattern here as you
might notice whereby there's one yellow
in the middle and then there's the two
red and the four green there's kind of
an implicit structure there if you will
and what if I do start to think in two
dimensions and instead of laying out an
array of lockers like this on the x-axis
only what if I kind of like Slide the
four up and pull the uh the the one the
three the five down and kind of draw
this in two Dimensions instead well let
me do that as by separating these things
like this such that now let me propose
that each of these squares maybe it
doesn't have to be contiguous it can be
anywhere in the computer's memory but I
can't have these crazy gaps among them
how could I perhaps keep these things
connected conceptually what should I add
to the picture if you
will yeah branches say again so branches
metaphorically here and more technically
in the language of C maybe just some
arrows some pointers so I won't bother
drawing things as rectangles constantly
let me propose that we're now just
abstracting away what a node is but let
me claim that each of these squares now
is a node and a node might have a number
but it might also have a pointer heck
maybe even two or more pointers and let
me draw those now I don't care about
addresses like ox1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 n
anymore let's just draw our pointers
with arrows but now let me propose that
we could very well think about this as a
tree storing what was previous
previously array data but now each of
these nodes can be anywhere in memory
and moreover even though I've kind of
painted myself into a corner visually on
the screen so long as there's more
memory in the computer I could put the
number zero over here I could put the
number eight over here and I'm if I'm
smart I could probably if I want to
insert other numbers like 2.5 or 1.5 or
values in between you know I bet we
could kind of make room by swiveling
things around and just kind of hanging
things off of these branches slightly
differently and so what does this gain
me well if I instead start to model my
data not single dimensionally but in two
dimensions and I connect those nodes
with these pointers what can I now do I
think I just gave myself back binary
search why suppose I'm searching for the
number five how do I find it Well just
like in a family tree where you might
visually start reading from top to
bottom I'm always going to start from
the so-called root of a binary search
tree this is just like the list pointer
that kicks off the whole link list
process
this is the so-called route all right
here I am at the number four I want to
find the number five what decision can I
make when I see that I'm currently at
the number four just like the phone book
from week zero where is five
not it's not to the left and if I were
had you know built a little mobile here
or something we could very dramatically
snip off this Branch this is this is
like very lowbudget animation these
nodes could like fall to the ground and
we're left with half of essentially a
tree but what do I now know it's
obviously the five to the right so let
me go to the right six is obviously not
the one I'm looking for but what do I
now know about the five well five is
less than the sixth so I can sort of
snip this off here because I know it's
not going to be down there and I can
follow the remaining Arrow here and
voila I just found it and now without
getting into the weeds of the math I've
got here what Seven Elements that's
roughly eight if I round up and if I do
some log base two I actually 1 two three
is the key detail here the height of
this tree
is three because I took a list of size
seven and IED it and IED it in order to
let it dangle in these two Dimensions
plus or minus one for rounding sake so
what do I get back I now have binary
search but it's not like H the middle of
the middle of the middle I now follow
these arrows in one of two directions so
each of these nodes now has an INT and
maybe a left pointer and a right pointer
but you can call them anything you want
and so I've gotten back binary search
and dynamism because if you want to add
zero or eight or 9 or 10 we can just
dangle them at the bottom of the binary
search tree so what would this look like
in code but we won't actually implement
it line by line well here was previously
our definition of a node for a link list
which was onedimensional if you will
even though it might bounce up and down
on the screen it was still just a line
if you will well let me get rid of the
single pointer in the linked list let me
make a little bit of room here in this
type death and let me propose that we
just add two pointers each of which is a
struct node star one will be called left
by convention one will be called right
by convention and so long as someone not
me not today not in class writes the
code that stitches together this data
structure too handling both the left
child and the right child so to speak I
think we can indeed stitch together that
two-dimensional structure and moreover
once you have this in memory you can
translate pretty elegantly to code
binary search itself using a principle
we talked about recently too here is for
instance a function that I'll write by
just clicking through steps called
search whose purpose in life is to
return a Boolean true or false the
number I'm looking for is in the tree
this search function therefore takes two
arguments the number I'm looking for
called number and then a pointer to the
tree the so-called root of the tree now
how can I Implement binary search in
code will recall our brief discussion of
recursion it turns out recursion is a
beautiful technique and honestly more
obvious technique when you have two
dimensional structures which finally
after five plus weeks we now do here's
maybe my first line of code here if the
tree is null then obviously return false
you've handed me an empty tree there's
nothing going on obviously the number
you're looking for is not going to be
here so that's my like safe base case to
make sure I don't screw up and recurse
infinitely well what else might be the
case well if the number I'm looking for
is less than the tree's own number and
now recall that trees a node star so
even though I'm calling it a tree it's
really the current node that's been
passed in so if the number I'm looking
for is less than the current nodes
number then I must know that the number
I'm looking for is to the left so to
speak so how can I solve that well this
is where the magic of recursion just
return whatever the answer is to calling
search again but on a sub tree if you
will this is the sort of equivalent of
snipping off half of the tree pass in
the left sub tree if you will with the
same number else if the number you're
looking for isn't less than the current
nodes number but greater than snip off
the other subtree instead and just
return whatever search says it finds in
the right subtree here and then there's
a fourth and final case what else could
be true
logically
[Music]
yeah perfect if the number you're
looking for equals equals the number in
this node then I'm just going to return
true and you might recall from our
recurring discussions of design I don't
strictly need to ask that explicitly
either there's no node it's to the left
it's to the right or you found it so I
can just Whittle that down as usual to
an else and this now returns my true so
here too this is where recursion once
you get comfy with it sort of gets
pretty elegant and cool in the sense
that wow even though there's a lot of
lines here I mean there's only a few
interesting lines a lot of it's like
Curly braces at that which strictly
speaking I could get rid of and so
recurs lends itself to Elegance when it
comes to traversing these
two-dimensional data structures as well
so that is in code how you might
Implement something like
search questions then on these
trees we have dynamism we can insert
more nodes to them they're faster
because we get B search back but but but
there's got to be a price paid any
downsides or question or
downside okay let me come back to that
in just one sec downside though what
price of we paid for this dynamism and
for this binary
searchability even though I've
abstracted it away in the
picture say
again we're using a lot of memory right
I'm kind of misleading you now because
I'm just drawing these little squares
with the simple numbers but there's
actually three things in there a four
byte integer an 8 by left pointer a 8 by
right pointer so we're already up to 16
20 bytes now to store individual ins
that's probably okay though if memory is
relatively cheap and voluminous as it
nowadays is but these are the kinds of
trade-offs and here too you see a hint
of why some people still do like and use
C and in fact it's so omnipresent
because when you have C you can really
fine-tune how much memory is being used
for Better or For Worse under the hood
as we transition soon to python these
decisions get made for you and you have
much much less control about how many me
how much memory is being used by your
program because someone else made those
designed decisions for you
question
is it bad if we don't know the parent
node uh not necessarily there's no
reason why you need to have pointers in
both directions however that can lend
itself to efficiency by spending more
space and having arrows go up too you
can actually save more time when
searching the tree in other context this
though would be the canonical way the
typical way to implement it um but
absolutely just like a doubly link list
that could help you solve other problems
too all right so turns out I'm kind of
overselling binary search trees there
are perversions of them so to speak
whereby they won't actually behave as
advertised for instance here's a a good
situation suppose you've got an empty
tree initially and you insert the number
two well it's got to go somewhere so it
might as well become the root of this
binary search tree and let's assume that
someone wrote the code to do this now
you want to insert the number one and
you want to maintain the searchability
of this tree well it's important to note
that binary search tree is different
from tree if you just got a tree in
memory there is no social contract with
where the numbers need to go they can be
completely random all over the place
binary search tree means that you can do
binary search means that any node here
is going to be greater than every node
here and less than every node here and
that's a definition it's a recursive
structural definition that must be true
to be a binary search tree or BST so if
we maintain that property ourselves let
me insert two let me insert one one
belongs there by that definition let me
insert three three belongs there by that
definition but I kind of got lucky in
that I in the story inserted two and
then one and then three let me propose a
sort of perversion of the algorithm
whereby we just get unlucky let me
propose that we insert in uh insert one
first and then we insert two well where
does two go well logically it goes to
the right because it's larger all right
now the user inserts three where does it
go okay it goes there logically and how
does this story un fold the user inserts
four five six it's wonderfully sorted in
advance by luck but this is a perversion
of the structure in what
sense it's still technically a binary
search tree but what does it look more
like it really is devolving if you will
into a linked list and so if you the
programmer don't Implement a binary
search tree with some kind of repairs
going on such that as soon as something
gets whoa a little too long in stringy I
think I can fix this it's going to be an
annoying line number of lines of code
which we're not going to write here or
or in a pet but we could kind of pivot
this thing right and we could just
rejigger things so that the two becomes
the new root the one becomes the left
child the three becomes the right child
but that's what like two three plus
lines of code it's possible it's doable
but it's it's extra work it's extra code
so unless you write that code though and
maintain balance of these trees just
because it's a binary search tree does
not mean its height is going to be log
base 2 of n the height could be log it
could be n in which case you don't get
those properties so when it comes to
looking up in a balanced binary search
tree yes it's log in but if it's
unbalanced if you don't add that
additional logic and those repairs so to
speak you could it could devolve into
Big O of N and this is a whole category
of algorithms and fanciness that you
would explore in a higher level course
on algorithms and data structures
there's lots of way to do that sort of
fixing that I'm alluding to in the
picture there on the screen
screen all right a few other data
structures if you will toward an end of
a sort of computer science Holy Grail so
log in is repeatedly a really good place
to end up we started in week zero when
we got log in we lost it this earlier
today by introducing link list but we
just got it back albeit at the price of
spending more space but the Holy Grail
so to speak when it comes to algorithms
would not be Big O of n certainly
definitely not n squar like our mer like
our bubble sorts and selection sorts and
not even Big O of Logan what's better
than all of
those big O of one constant time right
that's the Holy Grail because if we
could store huge amounts of data but
find it instantly in one step or two
steps or heck even 10 or 20 steps but
independent of the size of the data
structure that's pretty powerful I mean
that's the secret sauce of the Googles
and the twitters of the world trying to
get back results really really fast well
it turns out another abstract data type
or abstract data structure might be
something called a dictionary just like
the maram Webster Oxford English
dictionaries that you might know which
associate say words with definitions
well you can think of a dictionary
really abstractly as this like two
columns maybe on a spreadsheet of sorts
where the left column represents
something and the right column
represents something else like the word
is on the left and its definition is on
the right and that's almost literally
what a dictionary is on paper you've got
all the words and all the definitions
right next to it but more generally in
Computing a dictionary really just has
not words and definitions per se but key
value pairs this is a term of Art and
we're going to see this again and again
especially as we transition to web
programming keys and values key is what
you use to look for something the value
is what you find ultimately via that key
so that's the generic term there we've
seen key value pairs really in the past
in week zero we talked about your
contacts in your iPhone or Android phone
uh being an app that has a whole bunch
of contexts presumably alphabetized by
first name or last name or the like well
one one of those contact cards
ultimately has someone's number for
instance like John Harvard in this case
so in that type of application the keys
is the name like John Harvard that you
use to find information and the value is
the number that you find there or if
there's more information like where he
lives and uh email address and the like
the whole contact card could be the
value thereof the key is what you use to
look up John Harvard now back in week
zero oh and rather the corresponding
table then if we draw this in two
columns wouldn't be word and definition
or key value generically it would be
name and number for instance so we're
just slapping some new terminology on
this old contact problem well this is
the picture we drew way back in week
zero whereby I claimed that log of n was
really really good and indeed it was and
has been since but the Holy Grail would
indeed be something more like this in
this dashed Green Line constant time and
maybe not literally one step but a fixed
number of steps that even as the problem
gets huge and you go way way out on the
right of the X AIS the problem does not
depend on the side the uh the uh the
time to solve the problem does not
depend at all on the size of the problem
itself you can have a thousand contacts
or 100,000 contacts constant time means
it takes the same number of steps no
matter what well how can we get to that
point well there's a couple of final
building blocks today and there's one
called hashing and this is something
that will recur a few times but for now
hashing is all about taking as input
some value
and outputting a simpler version thereof
so for instance here's a a gratuitously
large deck of cards which are all the
more visible as a result and in a deck
of cards typically you've got like what
52 cards plus maybe the Jokers and
whatnot and each of those cards has a
number of sorts and a suit on it and
here are literally four buckets on the
stage and how might I go about sorting
these cards not just by number but also
by suit well you could certainly like
spread them all out and sort of make a
mess of things and just kind of reason
your way through it and get everything
in order according to suit and corded by
number but most of us even if you don't
have four buckets at home probably are
going to do something a little more
intuitive feels like an optimization
where if I find like the nine of Hearts
I'm going to put that into the hearts
bucket the King of Spades I'm going to
put that into the Spades bucket the jack
of diamonds over here and I'll do this
with the Queen of Diamonds and uh the
Ace of clubs here and the three here and
the 10 here and even though it's still
going to be 52 steps why am I and maybe
at home like why would you perhaps do
this step
first what's the value of bucketization
reduces the probability of errors or the
like and what I'm doing here to give it
a technical term is that I'm hashing the
values I'm taking as input a card like
this and I'm reducing it more simply
from a larger domain to a much smaller
range if you will so here's a domain of
like 52 possibilities I want to map that
to a range of four possible outcomes the
Diamonds the clubs the carts or the
Spades here and by doing that I'm just
shrinking the size of the problem so
hashing does that it's like literally an
F ofx type Arrangement whereby you pass
something in and you get back a simpler
known value well a hash function more
technically is the algorithm or even the
math or even the code that implements
that idea converting something bigger to
something smaller to this indeed finite
range of values and it turns out that
hash tables are a wonderful application
of arrays and length lists to try to
Leverage The Best of Both Worlds the
goal being theoretically to achieve that
Holy Grail of constant time and that's
going to be a bit of an overstatement
because you're not always going to
achieve it exactly but at least we can
get a little closer there too so with
hash tables you have something that
looks like this this is just an array
this is an artist rendition of drawing
it vertically instead of horizontally
but that's just a a detail graphically
and this array for instance maybe uh is
of size 26 and where am I going with
this well how does Apple how does Google
Store your contexts alphabetically in
your phone and search for things quickly
well they might they probably
alphabetize at least in English
according to a through z or if we
convert that to numbers it's like what
65 through whatever or really 0 through
25 suffices if we're using an array of
size 26 we start counting at zero and we
count up to 25 but let's abstract that
away as just letters of the alphabet so
maybe what Google and apple are doing in
your phone is storing all of the A's up
there all of the Z's down there and
everything else in between and so this
works pretty well if you start adding
your friends and your family so for
instance and I'll get rid of the letter
so it's to not distract uh alvus might
go in that first spot because a you
subtract the 65 maps to zero so we put
him in the first bucket the a bucket uh
maybe Zacharias ends up all the way at
the end there and then in the middle
might here be Hermione and if we do this
dot dot dot you keep adding all of your
classmates you might get a uh contact
database that has all of this data here
in now each of these nodes they're drawn
differently because this is just another
artist rendition these rectangles these
long rectangles represent a contact card
like John Harvard's that's got the name
maybe email definitely phone number and
things like that so this seems great why
how can I find Albus well I go to the a
bucket how do I find Zacharias I go to
the Z bucket how do I find Hermione I go
to the H bucket but but but I've done
this very deliberately what problem will
arise eventually assuming you have
enough classmates
yeah there'll be too many people too
many contacts for all of the available
spaces in the array there's still some
room here but I'm pretty sure if I think
back to this particular class uh we've
got not hermy but also Harry who's also
an H Hagrid who's also an H so where do
I put them I could just put them
arbitrarily in any of the open spots but
then you lose the immediacy of jumping
right to the H right to the a right to
the Z but now that we have link lists we
can kind of combine these ideas right
use an array to get to the first letter
of the name you care about and then if
you have a collision so to speak whereby
someone's already there you don't do
something stupid like put Harry down
here just because it's available or
maybe Hagrid down here just because it's
available because then you're losing the
immediacy of the lookup why don't you
just kind of stitch them together in a
linked list now what does this mean this
means for most of the characters here
you have constant time lookup you look
up alvas boom you're done Zacharias boom
you're done okay Harry Hermione Hagrid
it might be one two or three steps so
that's actually devolving into something
linear but here we make a distinction
today between theoretical running times
which we keep talking about and honestly
a clock on the wall running times that
actual humans care about this is way
faster than a linked list because you
don't have to search every name it's
even faster than a an array because you
don't need to do binary search
you can literally for most of the names
find them in constant time one step and
again it's not theoretically constant
because these if you only befriend
people who have H names it's going to be
a crazy long link list anyway so again
it really kind of depends on what the
nature of the data is here but this is
pretty close to constant time and in
fact how could we get even closer how
could we reduce the probability of
collisions for the H's or any other
letters how could we avoid putting too
many H names together
say a little
L okay yeah so we could add another
dimension if you will but let's not add
a third dimension per se but let's
indeed look at not just the first letter
of everyone's name but the first and the
second and in fact let's see if that
gets us a little uh further along so let
me go ahead and propose if you go
through the whole Harry Potter Universe
there's actually a lot of collisions if
we keep going and so we've got the L's
here the RS the S's and so forth well
let's clean this up here Hermione
originally went to the H location but
let's decrease the probability of
collisions there and everywhere else
instead of putting hermion Harry and
Hagrid Al together let's go ahead and do
this instead instead of labeling these
buckets A through Z let's just give
ourselves more buckets so in fact this
might be H well instead of H maybe this
should be ha and then this should be HB
HC HD h e HF now some of those are a
little nonsensical cuz I can't think of
names that match most of those but it's
deterministic at least we know the
bucket will be there which is important
even if it's empty and now we can put
Hermione here we can put Harry here but
uhoh we didn't do this perfectly well
Hagrid still Collide so let me come back
to you how can we reduce the probability
of Harry and Hagrid
colliding yeah so we could look at the
third letter okay so let me try that
instead of ha let's look at haa ha ha C
dot dot dot haq dot dot dot h h e q h e
r hes and so forth and now I think those
names and probably all the others we saw
are now much more cleanly distributed
there's much lower probability of
collisions unless two people have like
almost the same names or one is like a
prefix of the other but but but even
though we're now closer than ever to
constant time because the odds that we
hit a collision and have to devolve to a
link list or much lower what's the
downside that's not completely obvious
from how I've depicted this on
screen what's the price I'm paying here
yeah this is a huge amount of memory the
number of cells here in the array is now
what 26 * 26 * 26 for the first the
second and the third possible characters
all combinatorically combined here
that's a lot I didn't even draw them I
have the dot dot dot to evoke that
instead that's a huge amount of memory
this is a very sparse data set now and
odds are you're going to waste so much
memory even for the names like Hae ha
like HQ like I can't even think of names
so many of those buckets are going to be
empty not to mention the AAA and the zzz
and everything else in between so it's a
trade-off and it might be too expensive
a trade-off and so you might have to
tolerate something like the collisions
we had earlier whereby even though they
might very well happen at least you uh
are decreasing the probability by
perhaps having more buckets like this
and in fact if I rewind now to where we
might have gone with this here here's
how we might represent these nodes in
the tree previously in the past we've
had a person who had a string name and a
string number AKA now Char star and so
here now might be how in this hash table
we represent someone's name and number
as well as a pointer to the next element
in the list we let me rewind just to the
picture here we keep drawing different
shapes because again these are
abstractions who really cares if they're
to scale now we've got enough room for
the person's name not pictured on the
screen is herm's number that's somewhere
in this rectangle but yes pictured here
in this little square is a pointer to
the next node in the list so by storing
name and number maybe her address maybe
her mailing address whatever in addition
to a pointer allows each of these nodes
to be connectable just like the nodes in
a linked list but where they're starting
is in an array so the array gets us like
126 of or gets us um Narrows the problem
from size 26 to one gets us to the link
list in question hopefully it's a single
person or perhaps it has more than that
meanwhile what is the hash table itself
the hash table the whole thing is
literally just an array I've hardcoded
the simplest version of size 26 but what
do each of those boxes in the vertical
array represent just a pointer to
potentially a node a node in a length
list and if there's no one there if
there's no one in location y or X or the
like in that Universe well it's just a
null pointer signifying there's no uh
one there but if there is it's going to
be a pointer to a valid node from which
we can get to any of the others as well
and that so-called hash function just
like the one I did with the greeting
cards well it's just an a black box if
you will but implemented somewhere in
code like in C and so if you pass in
Albus what is the hash value of Albus
well in the first version of the story
with 26 buckets it should be a zero if
you pass in Zacharias it should be 25
and so just as my cards were being
hashed to one of 1 2 3 four values now
these names are being hashed to one of
26 possibilities or 26 time 26 or 26 to
the 3 power if you have more and more
granularity than
that questions on this implementation
now of this idea of a hash
[Music]
table if uh if you say that again with
the
[Music]
null oh a good question so if there's so
much spareness there's all of these
empty cells in the array couldn't you
just go in and free them or delete them
or just kind of shrink the array and not
have a a AA and aab and a a only have
the prefixes two or three characters
that you need you absolutely could do
that but now what you you lose is the
arithmetic benefit of being able to map
each letter to a number if you start uh
freeing up unused space you don't know
that Zacharias is necessarily at
location 25 Albus is still going to be
at location zero but if you've deleted
some of the elements in the middle
Zacharias could be at 24 if you've
deleted one 23 if you've deleted another
and so you don't have that arithmetic
immediacy that you need in order to
index into the array with constant time
and the same is going to be true if it's
uh two letters or three letters you need
to be able to trust that you can do some
quick math and jump to the right index
in constant time and that's again the
appeal of these arrays so when it comes
to the running time of a hash table
inserting values into it searching for
values therein at the end of the day it
technically is Big O of n because in the
craziest case you might have a huge
fancy hash table but everyone in the
universe has a name starting with h and
then it just evolves into a really long
link list just like a binary search tree
could do the same but if you choose a
smarter hash function maybe you mitigate
that and you don't rely only on the
first letter but on the second or the
third as well or some other combination
of that input and make your hash
function smarter odds are if you get a
good hash function you want it get it to
be more of like order of n divided by K
where K means constant mathematically
and so K is the number of buckets so
ideally you want like a uniform
distribution you want like this many
people here this many people here you
don't want there to be some or no people
you want a uniform statistical
distribution and maybe you get that from
Human names maybe you don't but that's
kind of the challenge of a hash function
of course Big O of n over K is not a
thing because we always throw away
constants like K so it's still Big O of
n but again the distinction today is
that okay yes academically you learned
in cs50 that sure it's Big O ofin but my
God it's 26 times faster if you do the
hash function well and you spread
everyone out over the hash table and
that's the appeal of these kinds of
structures
and we've got one more for you if I may
something now known as a try so it turns
out that a try is even cooler if you
like this kind of thing in that it does
not devolve into Big O of n it is truly
constant time but there's going to be a
price there's going to be a gotcha a try
is sort of a fancier tree and it's short
for retrieval but pronounced try for
weird historical reasons but a try is a
tree each of whose nodes is an array
right so this is all like crazy mashups
now people started inventing data
structures just by combining different
ones unfortunately a lot of the good
ideas are taken but you just have
benefits from certain aspects of those
data structures and combining them
ideally gives you the best of both
worlds so to speak so here might be the
root of a try it's literally a big node
a big rectangle but it's actually an
array so there's like 26 locations in
this picture here and here's how you use
a try for instance to store names just
like the hash table it you treat each of
the elements of that array in that node
as like a letter of the alphabet so a
through z or 0 through 25 and if you
want to store someone's name in here you
do so as follows if you want to store
like uh an H you index into the H
location and if you want to store the
second letter of someone's name like an
a well you add another node below it and
such one is connected to the other and
you then identify the a in that array
and then you go on and maybe put a g if
the goal is to store spoiler now Hagrid
in this data structure and then the r
and the I and then the D but when you
get to the D the end of the name you
have to somehow flag that this is the
end of a name that we've embedded into
this data structure so whereas all of
these are called out in white just to
make obvious what we're connecting to
what green has to be like a bull that's
true that just indicates like the buck
stops here like d is the last letter in
someone's actual name and what's kind of
cool now about a try is that we can
repeat this for other names as well so
for instance here is where we might put
Harry as well and notice they share a
common prefix ha for Hagrid ha for Harry
so we're reusing some of these nodes
some of these arrays we can even slip
Hermione in here too borrowing only the
H but she gets the H then the E then r r
m i o n e and so forth and we Mark at
the end of her name too that she's in
there now what's the takeaway here well
what is the running time of a try how
many steps does it take to find someone
in this data structure and let me zoom
out so that it sort of suddenly becomes
a massive data structure with even more
in it uh maybe it looks sorry no I'll
keep it on this one maybe it looks a
little something like this with just
these three names but how many steps
does it take to find Hagrid or Harry or
Hermione no matter how many names are in
this data structure there's three at the
moment but it takes what h a g r i d so
six steps to find Hagrid uh h a r r y
five steps to find Harry h e r m i o n e
eight steps to find Hermione but notice
that those steps are only dependent on
what the lengths of the human's names
and let's assume that no one's going to
have a infinitely long name it's going
to max out at what like eight no maybe
eight 18 maybe 20 30 there's actually
some pretty long human names out there
but it's going to be finite you know
it's abounded whereas most contexts n
could grow forever so what's compelling
here is if you assume that the longest
name is I don't know 50 for the sake of
a theme here then you know that finding
anyone in this data structure will take
you no more than 50 steps 50 is thus a
constant which means you have big O of
one running time it doesn't matter if
there's a million people in this phone
book or a billion people in this phone
book that's going to definitely add more
nodes to it but it's still going to take
you h a r uh sorry h a g r i d six steps
to find Hagrid h a r r y five steps to
find Harry even if there's a billion
other people in that data structure so
now we actually do seem to have constant
time if you assume that there's going to
be a bound on the length of the name why
don't we use tries for everything then
what's the price we're paying for this
data structure even though we've
represented just three characters here
yeah it's a lot of memory yeah and you
can see it even with these three names
most of the squares on the screen are
empty like bites and bits that are there
and are allocated and they need to be
there because you need to be able to do
that arithmetic thing of this being zero
this being 25 so you can jump from boom
boom boom boom based on each of the
letters but it's a hugely sparse data
structure which means it takes up a
crazy amount of memory now maybe that's
tolerable especially for short names but
that's going to be the trade-off as well
and this is such a tension in Computing
almost any time you want to improve time
you want to speed up the efficiency the
speed of your algorithm you're going to
spend space if by contrast you want to
decrease the amount of space you might
very well have to increase the running
time it is indeed this seesaw back and
forth and you your colleagues your
company need to decide what resource is
the most precious heck it might be much
harder to code one of these data
structures than another you're a human
your time is valuable do you really want
to spend hours implementing a try when
you know hey in 30 minutes I can bang
out an array nowadays or a linked list
even there too development time is going
to be yet another resource and why
sometimes there's good code or bad code
it depends on what you're prioritizing
so what do each of these nodes look like
in a try well we can keep calling it a
node this is a very generic term for
just a container in these data
structures in this story though let me
claim that everyone has a number like a
phone number a string akhr star every
every node has 26 children or
technically an array of size 26 that can
point to more of these nodes notice that
I don't need to store the name of
someone in a try because it's implicit
in the path that you take to find them
so that's a minor optimization but it
saves us some space but this would be
just a different data structure we could
use to actually solve this problem as
well albeit at a very expensive cost and
what do we need our variable to be that
stores the try just like four we just
need a single pointer that hangs on to
the root of this structure that's null
if it's empty or non-null if it's
actually pointing at
something any questions then on
tries and if it's feeling like a lot the
fire the the fire hydrant it is we
started with arrays then link list then
tries but questions on how we've just
assembled from these basic building
blocks
[Music]
yeah a good question why is this not uh
size 26 uh it's just like with the try
just like with the link list before it
just tends to be en code convenient to
have a separate additional pointer
that's small that just points to the
beginning of the data structure because
that way it can be null thereby clearly
indicating there are no nodes the whole
structure is empty if you allocated one
of those nodes you absolutely could but
then you'd be just wasting space even if
it's empty and it creates an ambiguity
so just having a single pointer linked
to the beginnings of all of these things
is a good thing other questions now on
tries or trees or hash tables or
arrays so what problems might arise well
here's a counter example what names are
manifest in this try
here feel free to just call it
out what do you
see Danielle and Danielle so presumably
if these are two uh names here one of
which is a prefix of another notice that
the data structure still works and I
chose you know a friend's name and then
appended a couple of more characters to
it that's also a name because we have
here d a n i e l and the green
technically is implemented as a bull or
something like that that indicates a
word stops here but we don't want to
preclude storing Danielle as well who's
a super string if you will of Daniel and
so that's okay too so long as the
structure allows for the pointers to
keep going so even that works out okay
whereas it might not have otherwise and
in terms of the running time just to be
clear at the end of the day tries do
give you actual constant time for
insertions lookups deletions and the
like because it's dependent only on the
length of the input the key if you will
and not on how many other people are in
your phone or a dress book and now
thought we'd conclude with a visual if
you've gotten out into the square anyone
recognize this okay okay sweet green a
local salad place what are we looking at
here and what's its connection to today
um you're about to become all the
geekier in the real world cuz you will
start to see data structures
everywhere what is this or how does this
work maybe in salad form who's been to
Sweet
green okay either of you so how does
this
[Music]
work okay good so if you order a salad
for someone named L when it's ready they
put it in the l section here and so this
is kind of a set of key value pairs
right if L is the first letter of
someone's name the value hopefully is
the salad and so what you kind of have
here is a dictionary key value pairs
where it's not words and definitions
it's names and salads and you can think
of this too as kind of a hash table why
even though it actually doesn't fit on
one long shelf cu the store is only so
big this is really an array and
apparently a is missing or maybe it's
around around the corner but this array
just happens to wrap onto multiple lines
but it's still conceptually a single
Dimension but suppose two people have
the name L what do they do
typically yeah so maybe they they well
if they run put that much effort into it
they might look at the second letter and
then the third letter odds are this is
not that interesting a problem to solve
optimally in that way but they probably
do start stacking the salads on top of
each other maybe scooching it over just
a little bit and so what do you have
there well now you start to view the
lens through like cs50 glasses like okay
you have an array and then you have like
these link lists that are sort of
growing here but even then you run into
a problem why because it's not really a
link list because at some point you're
going to hit the boundary here so it's
kind of like an array of arrays because
you can only fit what like three or four
salads here and so long story short we
started today deliberately talking about
real world things like stacks and cues
and even though it did escalate quickly
into binary search trees and hash tables
and tries even those things are
everywhere even though they don't call
them as such these are just solutions to
problems and now with this final week of
SE under your belt you have all the more
of a technical toolkit via which to
implement these things and code next
week we'll be able to trust that someone
else solved all these problems we'll
introduce Python and lines of code like
this will finally become lines of code
like that so that's the promise ahead
and we'll see you next
[Applause]
[Music]
time
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
all right this is cs50 and this is week
six wherein we finally transitioned from
scratch to see to now Python and indeed
this is going to be somewhat of a unique
experience in that just like a few weeks
past perhaps for the first time and now
uh today you're going to learn a new
language but the goal isn't just to
throw another fire hose of content and
syntax and whatnot at you but rather to
really equip you all to actually teach
yourself new languages in the future and
so indeed what we'll do today what we'll
do this coming week is sort of prepare
you to stand on your own and once python
is p a and the world has moved on to
some other language in some number of
years you'll be well equipped to figure
out how to wrap your mind around some
new syntax some new language and solve
problems as well now you recall in week
zero this is where we started just
saying hello to the world and that
quickly escalated just a week later in C
to see be something much much more
cryptic and if you've still sort of
struggled with some of the syntax find
yourself checking your notes or your
previous code like that's totally normal
and that's one of the reasons why there
are languages besides C out there among
them this language called python humans
over the decades have realized gee that
wasn't necessarily the best designed
decision or humans have realized wow you
know what now that computers have gotten
faster with more memory and more faster
CPUs we can actually do more with our
programming languages so just as human
languages evolve so do actual
programming languages and even within a
programming language there's typically
different versions We for instance have
been using version C11 of C which was
updated in 2011 um but python itself
continues to evolve and it's now up to
version three plus and so there too
these things will evolve in the coming
days thankfully what you're about to see
is hello world for the third time but
it's going to be literally this none of
the crazy syntax above or below fewer
semicolons if any fewer curly braces and
really a lot of the distractions get out
of the way so to get there let's
consider exactly how we've been
programming up until now so you write a
program in C and you've got hopefully no
syntax error so you're ready to build it
that is compil it and so you've run make
and then you've run the program like/
hello or if you think back to week two
where we took a peak underneath the hood
of what make is doing it's really
running the actual compiler something
called clang maybe with some command
line arguments creating a program called
hello and then you could do do/ hello so
today you're going to start doing
something similar in spirit but fewer
steps no longer will you have to compile
your code and then run it and then maybe
fix or change it and then compile your
code and run it and then repeat repeat
the process of running your code is
going to be distilled into just a single
step and the way to think of this for
now is that where a c is frequently used
as indeed a compiled language whereby
you convert it first to zeros and ones
Python's going to let you speed things
up whereby you the human programmer
don't have to compile it you're just
going to run what's called an
interpreter which by Design is named the
exact same thing as the language itself
and by running this program installed in
VSS code or eventually on your own Max
or PCS this is just going to tell your
computer to interpret this code and
figure out how to get down to that lower
level of zeros and ones but you don't
have to compile the code yourself
anymore so with that said let's consider
what the code is going to look like side
by side in fact let's look back at some
scratch blocks just like we did with C
in week one and do some side by sides
because even though some of the syntax
this week and Beyond's going to be
different like the ideas are truly going
to be the same there's not all that much
intellectually new just yet so whereas
in week zero we might have said hello to
the world with this purple puzzle piece
today of course uh or rather in week one
it looked like this in C but today
moving forward it's going to quite
simply look like this instead and if we
go back and forth for just a moment here
again is the version in C noticing the
very seike characteristics and just at a
glance here in Python I claim it's now
this what do you apparently need not
worry about
anymore what's gone so semicolon is gone
and indeed you don't need those to
finish most of your thoughts anymore
anything else so the back sln is absent
and that's kind of curious because we're
still going to get a new line but we'll
see that it's become the default and
this one's a little more subtle but now
the function is called print instead of
print F so it's a little more familiar
in that sense all right so when it comes
to using libraries that is code that
other people have written in the past
we've done things like hash include
cs50.h to use cs50's own header file or
standard IO or standard lib or string or
any number of other header files you
have all used well moving forward we're
going to give you for this first week a
similar cs-50 Library just very
short-term uh training wheels that will
quickly take off because in reality it's
a lot easier to do things in python as
we'll see but the Syntax for this now is
going to be to import the cs50 library
in this way and when we have now this
ability we can actually start writing
some code right away in fact let me
switch over to vs code here and just as
in the past I'll create a new file but
instead of creating something called C
I'm going to go ahead and create my
first program called hello.py using Code
space hello.py that of course gives me
this new tab and let me actually quite
simply do what I proposed print quote
unquote hello world without the back
slash without the semicolon without the
F in print and now let me go down to my
terminal window and I don't have to
compile it I don't have to do dot slash
i instead run a program called python
whose purpose in life is now to
interpret my code top to bottom left to
right and if I run python of hello.py
crossing my fingers as always voila now
I have printed out hello world so we
seem to have gotten the new line for
free in this sense where it's
automatically happening the dollar sign
isn't weirdly on the same line like it
want was in week one but that's just a a
minor detail here if we switch back to
now some other capabilities well indeed
with the cs50 library you can also not
just import the library itself but
specific functions and you'll see that
temporarily we're going to give you a
helper function called get string just
like in C that just makes it work
exactly the same way as in C and we'll
see a couple of other functions that
will just make life easier initially but
quickly will we take those training
wheels off so that nothing is indeed
cs50 specific all right well how about
functions more generally in Python let's
do a whirlwind tour if you will much
like we did in that first week of C
comparing one to the other so back in
our world of scratch one of the first
programs we wrote was this one here
whereby we asked the human their name we
then used the return value that was sort
of automatically stored in this answer
variable as a second argument to join so
that we could say hello David or hello
Carter so this was back in week one uh
week zero in week one we converted it to
this and here's a perfect example of
things like escalating quickly and again
this is why we start in scratch there's
just so much distraction here to achieve
the same idea but even today we're going
to chip away at some of that syntax so
in C we had to declare the argument as a
we had to declare the variable as a
string here we of course had the
semicolon and more well in Python the
comparable code now is going to look
more simply like this so semicolon is
again gone on both lines for that matter
so that's good what else appears to have
changed or disappeared yeah type of
variable yeah so I didn't have to
specifically say that answer is now a
string and indeed python is is
dynamically typed and in fact it will
infer from Context exactly what it is
you are storing in that variable other
details that seem a little bit
different little bit different what else
jumps out at you here I'll go back this
was the C version and maybe Focus now on
the second line because we've rather
exhausted the first here's now the
python version what's different here
yeah yeah there's no percent s anymore
there's no second argument at the moment
per se to print now it is still a little
weird it's as though I've like deployed
some addition here arithmetically but
that's not the case some of you have
programmed before and plus some of you
might know means what in this
context so to combine or more
technically anyone know the buzz word
yeah
to concatenate so to concatenate is like
the fancy way of what scratch calls
joining which is to take one string on
the left one string on the right and to
join them together to glue them together
if you will so this is not addition it
would be if it were numbers involved
instead but because we've got a string
hello comma and another string
implicitly in this variable based on
what the human typed in in response to
this get string function that's going to
concatenate hello comma space and then
David or Carter or whatever the human
has typed in but turns out there's going
to be different ways to do this in
Python and we'll show you a few
different ones and here too try not to
get too hung up on or frustrated by like
all of the different ways you can solve
problems odds are you're going to be
picking up tips and techniques for years
to come if you continue programming so
let's just give you a few of the
possible ways so here's a second way you
could print out hello comma David or
hello comma Carter but what has changed
in the previous version I used
concatenation explicitly and the space
here is important grammatically just so
we get that in the final phrase
now I'm proposing to get rid of that
space to add a comma outside of the
double quotes as well but if you think
back to C this probably just means that
print similar in spirit to print F can
take not just one argument but even two
and in fact because of this comma in the
middle that's outside of the double
quotes it's hello comma and then it will
be automatically concatenated with even
without using the plus to whatever the
value of answer is and by default just
for grammatical prettiness the print fun
function always gives you a space for
free in between each of the multiple
arguments you pass in we'll see how you
can override that down the line but for
now that's just another way to do it now
perhaps the better if slightly cryptic
way to do this or just the increasingly
common way is probably this third
version which looks a little weird too
and probably the weirdness jumps out
we've automatic we've suddenly
introduced these like Curly braces which
I promised were mostly gone and they are
but inside of this string here I've done
a curly brace which might mean what just
intuitively and here is sort of an
example of how you learn a new language
just kind of infer from Context how
python probably
works what might this mean yeah able to
tell that this is not one of the actual
stat
inside yeah so this is an indication
because the curly braces because this is
the way python was designed that we want
to plug in the value of answer not
literally a ANS w r and the fancy word
here is that the answer variable will be
interpolated that is substituted with
its actual value but but but and this is
actually weird looking and this was
introduced a few years ago to python
what else did I have to change to make
these curly braces work
apparently
yeah yeah there's this weird F and so
it's sort of like part of print F but
now it's inside the curly it's inside
the parenthesis there this is just the
way python designed this so a few years
ago when they introduced what are called
format strings or F strings you
literally prefix your quoted string with
the uh letter F and then you can use
trickery like this like putting curly
braces so that the value will be
substituted automatically if you forget
the F you're going to literally see
hello comma curly brace answer close
curly brace if you add the F it's indeed
interpolated the value is plugged in all
right questions on how we can just say
hello to the world via python in this
case
yeah if you do this without the without
the F if you omit the F you will
literally see c h e l l o comma curly
brace a NS w r close curly brace so in
fact let's do this let me go back to vs
code here quickly I've still got my file
called hello.py open and let me go ahead
and change this ever so slightly so I'm
going to go ahead and uh let's say from
cs50 import get string and that's just
the new syntax I propose using to import
a function from someone else's Library
I'm going to now go ahead and ask the
question uh let's go ahead and use get
string storing the result and answer so
get string quote unquote what's your
name question mark and then on this line
I'm going to deliberately make a mistake
here exactly to your question let me
just say hello comma answer and just
this now even though answer is a
variable Python's not going to be so
presumptuous as to just plug in the
value of a variable called answer what
it's going to do of course is if I type
in my name whoops I typed too fast let
me go ahead and rerun that again if I
run python of hello.py type in my name
and hit enter I get hello comma answer
well let me do one better let me apply
these curly braces as before let me
rerun python of hello.py What's Your
Name daav ID and here's again the answer
to your question now we get literally
the curly braces so the fix here
ultimately is just going to be to add
the F there rerun my program again with
daav ID and now hello comma David so
this is admittedly a little more cryptic
than the ones with the Plus the comma
but this is just increasingly common why
because you can read it left to right
it's nice and convenient it's less
cryptic than the percent s's so it's
sort of a new and improved version if
you will of printf in C based on Decades
of experience of programmers doing
things like this questions on printing
in this
way we're now on our way to programming
in
Python anything all right well what more
can we do with this language here well
let me propose that we consider that we
have for
instance a few other features that we
can add to the mix as well
namely let's say some data types as well
so let me flip over here to um back to
the slides and there's different data
types in python as we'll soon see but
they're not as explicit as we already
saw by using a string from get string
you don't have to explicitly State what
it is but you solve recall and see all
of these various data types and then in
python kind of nicely enough this list
is about to get shorter and so here is
our list in C here is an abbreviated
list in Python so we're still going to
have strings but they're going to be
more succinctly called stirs now St Str
we're still going to have in for
integers we're still going to have
floats for floating Point values we're
even going to have bulls for true and
false but what's missing now from the
list is long and floats and why is that
or rather long and double well recall
that in C those used more bits well in
Python the smaller data types previously
int and Float themselves just use more
bits for you and so you don't need to
distinguish between small and large you
just use one data type and the language
gives you a bigger range than before it
turns out though there's going to be
some other features as well of python
these data types one of which will be
called range another of which will be
list So Gone will be arrays we'll
actually use something literally called
a list tle sort of like XY pairs for
coordinates and things like that uh dict
for dictionaries so we have built-in
capabilities for storing keys and values
we'll see and even a set sort of
mathematically a set is like a
collection of values but it
automatically gets rid of duplicates for
you so all of these things we could
absolutely Implement in C if we wanted
and indeed in problem set five you've
been implementing your very own spell
checker using some form of hashtable
well it turns out that in Python you can
solve those same problems but perhaps a
little more readily in fact let me go
back over here to vs code and let me
propose that I do the following let me
go ahead and create a file called
dictionary. let me propose that I try to
implement say problem set five our spell
checker in Python instead of c and
Achieve ultimately the same kind of
behavior uh whereby I'll be able to
spell check a whole bunch of words so
this is jumping the gun a little bit
because you're about to see syntax will
revisit over the course of today but for
now I've got a new file called
dictionary. py and let me begin to
create uh some placehold ERS for
functions we'll see in just a bit that
in Python you can define a function
called check and that check function can
take a word as it's input and I'll come
back to this in just a moment in Python
I can define a second function like load
which itself will take a whole
dictionary just like in problem set five
and I'll go ahead and come back to the
implementation of this meanwhile we
might similarly Implement a function
called size which takes no arguments but
ultimately is going to return the size
of my dictionary of words and then last
lastly for consistency with problem set
five we might Define an unload function
whose purpose in life is to free any
memory that you've been using just to
give it back to the computer now odds
are whether you're still working on
speller or half finished speller like
you wrote a decent amount of lines of
code and indeed it's been by design a
challenge but one of the reasons for
these higher level languages like python
is that you can stand on the shoulders
of programmers before you and solve very
common problems much more quickly so
that you can f us on building your new
app or your web application or your own
project to solve problems of interest to
you so at the risk of crushing some
Spirits let me propose that in Python if
you want a dictionary for something like
a spell checker well that's fine go
ahead and give yourself a variable like
words to store all of those words and
just assign it equal to a dictionary or
dict for short in Python that will give
you a hashtable now it turns out in
speller recall you don't need to worry
about words and definition conditions
it's just about spellchecking the words
so strictly speaking we don't need keys
and values we just need keys so I'm
going to save myself a few more key
strokes by just saying that technically
in Python using a set suffices again a
set is just a collection of values with
no duplicates but they don't necessarily
have uh keys and values it's just one or
the other but now that I have on line
one I claim the equivalent in Python of
a hash table I can actually do something
like this here's how I might implement
the check function in Python if the word
passed into this function is in my
variable called words well return true
else go ahead and return false done wait
you're thinking if anything at all maybe
we want to handle lowercase instead of
just uppercase and lowercase well you
know what in Python if you want to force
a whole word to lowercase you don't have
to iterate over it with a loop you don't
have to use any of that ctype functions
or anything just say word. lower and
that will convert the whole thing to
lowercase for parody with the dictionary
all right how about something like the
load function in Python well in Python
you can open files just like in C for
instance in Python I might do open the
dictionary argument in read mode just
like fopen in Python I might do
something like this for each line in
that file let me go ahead and add to my
words variable that line and then let me
go ahead and close that file and I think
I'm done I'm just going to go ahead and
return true just because I think think
I'm already done now here too I could
nitpick a little bit technically if I'm
reading in every line from the file
every line in the dictionary ends with
technically a back sln but there's an
easy way to get rid of that uh just like
you might in see with an alternative
syntax what I'm actually going to do is
this let me grab from the current line
the current word by stripping off with
reverse strip R strip a function will
again see that just gets rid of the
trailing new line the back sln at the
end of that line and what I really want
to do then is add this word to that
dictionary meanwhile if I want to figure
out what the size is of my dictionary
well and see you're probably writing
code to iterate over all of those lines
and you're just going to uh count them
up using a variable not so in Python you
can just return the length of those
words and better still in Python you
don't have to manage your own memory no
more Malo no more free no more manual
thinking about memory the language just
deals with all of that for you so you
know what it suffices for me to just
return true and claim that unloading is
done for me and that's it again whether
you're in the middle of or already
finished this might perhaps suggest some
frustration but also Enlightenment in
this in that this is why higher level
languages exist you can build on top of
the same principles the same ideas with
which you've been dealing struggling
even this past week but you can now
express yourself all the more succinctly
like this one line implements a hash
table for you and all of this now now
just uses that hash table in a simpler
way any questions now on this keeping in
mind that the point nonetheless of
speller and P said 5 is to understand
what's really going on underneath the
hood and better still to notice this
this might seem all rather amazing but
let me go ahead and do this I've
actually got a couple of versions of
speller written here and I've got a
version written in C that I won't show
the source code for but I'm going to go
ahead and make that version of speller
in C and I'm going to go ahead here and
let's say split my window here for just
a moment and I'm going to go into a
python version of spell really that I
just wrote and on the left hand side
here let me go ahead and run speller the
version I compiled in C using a big text
like uh the Sherlock Holmes text which
is a whole lot of words in it and on the
right hand side let me run python of
spell. Pi which is a separate file I
wrote in advance just like we give you
speller.c and I'll similarly run this on
the Sherlock Holmes text and I'm going
to do my best to hit enter on the left
and the right of my screen at the same
time but we should see hopefully the
same list of misspelled words and the
timings thereof so here we go on the
right here we go on the
left all right sort of a race to see
which one wins here C is on the left
python is on the right okay
interesting hopefully Python's close
behind note that some of the is internet
delay and so it might not necessarily be
a crazy number of seconds but the system
is indeed using if we measure at a low
level how much time the CPU spent
executing my code C took a total of 1.64
seconds that was pretty fast even though
it took a moment more for all of the
btes to come over the Internet the
python version though took what 2.44
seconds so what might an inference be I
mean one maybe I'm just better at
programming in c than I am in Python
which is probably not true
but what else might you infer from this
example should we maybe give up on
python stick with
C no so where what might be going on
here like why is the python version that
I claim is correct and I think the
numbers all line up just not the
times where's the trade-off here well
here again is sort of this design
tradeoff
yeah yeah exactly in order to save the
human programmer time there's a lot more
features built into python more
functions more automatic management of
memory and so forth and you have to pay
a price like someone else's code is
doing all of that work for you but if
they've written some number of lines of
code those are just more lines of code
that need to be executed for you whereas
here the computer is at the risk of
oversimplifying only running my lines of
code so there's just less overhead and
so this is a Perpetual trade-off
typically when using a more userfriendly
and more modern language one of the
prices you might pay is performance now
there's a lot of smart computer
scientists in the world though trying to
push back on those same tradeoffs and so
these interpreters like the command I
wrote python technically can especially
if you run a program again and again
they can actually sort of secretly
behind the scenes compile your code for
you down to zeros and ones and then the
second the third the fourth time you run
that program it might very well be
faster so this is a bit of a head fake
here in that I'm running them once and
only once but we could get benefit over
time if we kept running the python
version again and again and perhaps
fine-tune the performance but in general
there's going to be this trade-off now
would you rather spend the 60 seconds I
wrote implementing a spell checker or
the 6 hours 16 hours you might be or
have spent implementing the same and C
you know probably not for productivity
sake this is why we have these
additional languages just for fun let me
flip over to another screen here and
open up a version of python that's
actually on on my in just a second on my
own uh Mac instead of the cloud so that
I can actually do something with
Graphics so here I just have a black and
white terminal window on my very own Mac
and I've pre-installed python just like
we've done so for VSS code in the cloud
for you uh notice that I've got this uh
photo of uh perhaps one of your favorite
TV shows here with the cast of The
Office notice all of the faces in this
image here and let me propose that we
try to find one face in the crowd sort
of CSI style whereby we want to find
perhaps the stranton Strangler so to
speak and so here is an example of this
this guy's face now how do we go about
finding this specific face in the crowd
well our human eyes obviously can pluck
him out especially if you're familiar
with the show but let me go ahead and do
this instead let me go ahead and propose
that we run code that I already wrote in
advance here this is a Python program
with more lines of code that we won't
dwell on for today but it's meant to
motivate what we can do from a a pillow
uh Library implying a python image
Library I want to import some type of
information called some type of some
feature called image so that I can
manipulate images not unlike our own
problem set 4 and this is kind of
powerful you in Python you can just
import face recognition as a library
that someone else wrote from there I'm
going to create a variable called image
I'm going to use this face recognitions
libraries load image file function it's
a little verbose but it's similar in
Spirit to F open and I'm going to open
office. jpeg I'm going to then declare a
second variable called face locations
plural because what I'm expecting to get
back per the documentation for this
library is a list of all of the faces
locations that are detected all right
then I'm going to iterate over each of
those uh faces using a for Loop that
we'll see in more detail I'm going to
then infer what the top right bottom and
left Corners are of that face and then
what I'm going to do here is show that
face alone if I've detected the face in
question so let me go ahead here and run
detect. and we'll see not just the one
face we're looking for but if I run
python of detect. piy it's going to do
all of the analysis I'll see a big
opening here now of all of the faces
that were detected in this here program
okay some better than others I guess if
you zoom in on catching someone typical
Angela if you now want to Now find that
one face I think we need to train the
software a bit more so let me actually
open up a second program called
recognize that's got more going on but
let me with a wave of a hand point out
that I'm now loading not only the
office. JPEG but also toby. JPEG to sort
of train the algorithm to find that
specific face and so now if I run this
second version recognize. with python of
recognize. py hold my breath for just a
moment it's an analyzing presumably all
of the faces you see the same original
photo but do you see one such face
highlighted here this adversion of the
code found Toby highlighted him with
this green and voila we have face
recognition so for better for worse this
is what's happening increasingly
societally nowadays and honestly even
though I didn't write the code live
because it's a good dozen or more lines
of code it's not terribly many and
literally all the authorities all we
have to do is import face recognition
and voila you have access like these
techn IES are here already but let's
consider for just a moment how did we
find Toby like how might that Library
even though we're not going to look at
its implementation details how does it
find Toby and distinguish him from all
of these other faces in the crowd what
might it be doing
intuitively think back even to pet 4
like what you yourselves have access to
data wise
yeah you know pixels in one area area
and a lot
of
that it's a lot of a lot of
simar yeah exactly and to summarize for
for camera here we have trained the
software if you will by giving it a
photo of Toby's face by so by looking
for the same or really similar pixels
especially if it's a slightly different
image of Toby we can perhaps identify
him in the crowd and what really is a
human face well at the end of the day
the computer only knows it as a pattern
of bits or really at a higher level a
pattern of pixels so maybe a human face
is perhaps best defined in general as
like two eyes and a nose and a mouth
that even though all of us look similar
structurally odds are the measurement
between the eyes and the nose and the
width of the mouth the skin tone and all
of these other physical characteristics
are patterns that software could perhaps
detect and then look sort of
statistically through the image looking
for the closest possible match to these
various measurement shapes colors and
sizes and the like and indeed that might
might be the intuition but what's
powerful here again is just how easy and
readily available this technology now is
all right so with that said let's
propose to consider what more we can do
with python itself get back to the
fundamentals so that you yourselves can
start to implement something along those
same lines so besides having access to
things like a get string function um the
cs50 library provides a few other things
as well namely in C we had these but in
Python we're going to have fewer in
Python our library short term is going
to give you not only get string but also
get in and get float why it's actually
just kind of annoying as we'll student
see to get back an integer or a float
from a user and just make sure that it's
an INT and a float and not like a word
like cat or dog or some string that's
not actually a number well we can import
not just the specific function get
string but we can actually import all of
these functions one at a time like this
as we'll soon see or you can even in
Python import specific functions from a
file one of you asked a while back when
you import when you include something
like cs50.h or standard i.h you're
actually getting all of the code in that
file which potentially can add bulk to
your own program or time in this case
when you import specific functions from
python you can be a little more narrowly
uh precise as to what it is you want to
have access to all right so with that
said let's go ahead and see what
conditionals look like in Python so in
the left hand side again here we'll see
scrp
and here for instance was just kind of a
contrived example asking if x is less
than y then say x is less than y in C it
looked like this in Python now it's
going to look like this instead and
here's before in C and here's after and
just to call out a few of the obvious
differences what has changed in Python
for conditionals it would
seem sort of what's the difference
yeah yeah so there's no more curly
braces and indeed you don't use those
what appears to be taking their place if
you might
infer what seems to have taken their
place what do you think so the colon at
the start of this line here but also
even more important now is this
indentation below it so some of you and
we know this from Office hours have a
habit of like uh indenting everything on
the left right and it's just kind of
this crazy mess to look at frustrating
for you surely but C and clang is pretty
tolerant when it comes to things like
Whit space in a program python uh-uh
they realized years ago that let's help
humans help themselves and just require
standard indentation so four spaces
would be the norm here but because it's
indented below that colon that indeed
indicates that this now is part of that
condition something else has gone
missing versus C in this conditional
what else is a little
simplified yeah so no more parentheses
you can still use them especially when
you need to logically to do order of
operations like in math but in this case
if you just want to ask a simple
question like if x less than y you can
just do it like that how about when you
have an if else well this is almost the
same here with these same changes in C
this looked like this and it's starting
to get a bit bulky at least if we use
our curly braces in this way in Python
we can tighten things up further even
though strictly speaking in C you don't
always need the curly braces but here
gone are the parentheses again gone are
the curly braces indentation is
consistent and we've just added another
keyword else with a colon but no more
semicolons as well how about something
larger like this and if else if else
this one's a little curious but in C it
looked like this if else if else in
Python it now looks like this and
there's perhaps one curiosity here that
honestly all these years later I still
can't remember how to spell it half the
time what's weird about
this what do you spot as
different uh yeah over
here yeah instead of else if it's l if
why apparently El space if was just too
many keystrokes for humans to type so
they condensed it into this way probably
means it's a little more distinguishable
too for the computer between the if and
the else to but just something to
remember now it's indeed L if and not
else if all right so what about
variables in Python I've used a couple
of them already but let's let's um
distill exactly how you define uh and
declare these things as well so in
scratch if we wanted to create a
variable called counter and set it equal
initially to zero we would do something
like this specify that it's an INT use
the assignment op operator and the
thought with a semicolon in Python it's
just simpler you name the variable you
use the assignment operator as before
you set it equal to some value and
that's it you don't mention the type you
don't mention the semicolon or anything
more what if you want to change a
variable like the counter by one that is
incremented by one you have a few
different ways here in C we saw syntax
like this where you can say counter
equals counter plus one which again
feels like illogical how can counter
equal counter plus one but again we read
this code really right to left updating
its value by one um in Python it's
almost the same you just get rid of the
semicolon so that logic is there but
recall in C we could do something
slightly different that we can also do
in Python in Python you can also more
succinctly do this plus equals and then
whatever number you want to add or you
can even change it to subtract if you
prefer sadly gone is something you've
probably typed a whole lot what was the
other way you can add
one Plus+ is no more sadly in Python
just too many ways to do the same thing
so they got rid of it in favor of just
this syntax here so keep that in mind as
well what about loops when you want to
do something in Python again and again
well in scratch in week zero here's how
we meowed three times specifically in C
we had a couple of ways of doing this
this was like the more mechanical
approach where you create a variable
called I you set it equal to zero you
then do while I is less than three the
following and then you yourself
increment I again and again mechanical
in the sense that like you have to
implement all of these gears and make
them turn yourself but this was a
correct way to do that in Python we can
still achieve the same idea but we don't
need the int keyword we don't need any
of the semicolons we don't need the
parentheses we don't need the curly
braces we can't use the Plus+ so maybe
that's a minor step backwards if you're
a fan but otherwise the code the logic
is exactly the same but there's other
ways to achieve this same idea recall
that in C we could also do this you
could use a for Loop which it does
exactly the same thing both are correct
both are arguably welld designed it's
kind of to each their own when it comes
to choosing between these in Python
though we're going to have to think
through how to do this so you don't do
the same for loop as in C the closest I
could come up with is this where you say
four I or whatever variable you want to
do the counting in literally the
preposition and then you use square
brackets here and we've used square
brackets before in the context of like
arrays and things like that and the 012
looks like an array in some sense even
though we've also seen arrays with curly
braces but these square brackets for now
denote a list python does not have
arrays an array is that contiguous chunk
of memory back to back to back that you
have to resize somehow by moving things
around in memory as per two weeks ago in
Python though you can just create a list
like this using square brackets and
better still as we'll see you can add or
even remove things from that list down
the road um this though is not going to
be very welld designed this will work
this will iterate in Python three
times but what might rub you the wrong
way about this design even if you've
never seen python before how does this
example not end well
yeah yeah like if you're making a large
list you have to type out each one of
these numbers like comma three comma
four comma 5 comma dot dot do 50 comma
dot dot dot 500 like surely that's not
the best solution to have all of these
numbers on the code on the screen
wrapping endlessly on the screen so in
Python another way to do this would be
to use a function called range which
technically is a data type unto itself
and this returns to you as many values
as you ask for it range takes some other
arguments as well but the simplest use
case here is if you want back the
numbers 0 1 and two a total of three
values you say hey python please give me
a range of three values and by default
they start at zero on up but this is
more efficient than it would be to
hardcode the entire list at once and the
best metaphor I could up with is
something like this like here for
instance is a deck of cards this is sort
of normal human size and there's
presumably 52 cards here so writing out
0 through 51 on code would be a little
ridiculous for the reasons you know it
would just be very unwieldy and ugly and
wrapping and all of that it would be the
phys it would be the virtual equivalent
of me like handing you all of these
cards at once to just deal with and
right you know they're not that big but
like it's a lot of cards to hold on to
it requires a lot of memory or physical
storage if you will what range does
metaphorically is if you ask me for
three cards I hand you them one at a
time like this so that at any point in
time you only have one number in the
computer's memory until you're handed
the next the alternative the previous
version would be to hand me all three
cards at once or all 52 cards at once
but in this case range is just way more
efficient you can do range of a thousand
that's not going to give you a list of a
thousand values all at once it's going
to give you a thousand values one at a
time reducing memory sign signicantly in
the computer itself all right so besides
this what about doing something forever
in scratch well we could do this
literally with a forever block which
didn't quite exist in C in C we had had
to hack it together by saying while true
because true is by definition TR always
true so this just in uh deliberately
induces an infinite Loop for us in
Python the logic's going to be almost
the same and infinite Loops in Python
tend to actually be even more common
because you can always break out of them
as you couldn't see in Python it looks
like this and this is slightly more
subtle but gone are the curly braces
gone or the parentheses but ever so
slight difference
toal capital T for true and it's going
to be a capital f for false stupid
little differences eventually you're
going to mistype one or the other but
these are the kinds of things to keep an
eye out and to start recognizing in your
mind's eye when you read code questions
now on any of these building
blocks
yeah
I in the for Loop was I re uh it was set
to zero on the first iteration then one
on the next then two on the third and
the same thing for range it just doesn't
use up as much memory all at once other
questions now on any of these building
blocks of
python no all right well let's go ahead
and build something a little more than
hello let me propose that over here we
Implement maybe the the simplest of
calculators here so let me go back to vs
code here open my terminal uh window and
open up say a file called
calculator. and in calculator. we'll
have an opportunity to explore some of
these building blocks but we'll allow
things to escalate pretty quickly to
more interesting examples so that we can
do the same thing ultimately as well and
in fact let me go ahead and do this
moreover I've brought some code with me
in advance uh for instance something
called calculator 0. C from the first
week of C
and let me go ahead and split my window
here in fact so that I can now do
something like uh this let me move this
over here here calculator. Pi so now I
have on the left of my screen
calculator. C or calculator z.c because
that's the first version I made and
calculator. Pi on the right let me go
ahead and Implement really the same idea
here so on the right hand side the
analog of including cs50.h would be from
cs50 import get int if I want to indeed
use this function now I'm going to go
ahead and give myself a variable X
without defining its type I'm going to
use this get int function and I'm going
to prompt the user for X just like in C
I'm then going to go ahead and prompt
the user for another int like y here
just like in C and at the very end I'm
going to go ahead and do print X Plus Y
and that's it now granted I have some
comments in my C version of the code
just to remind you of what each line is
doing but I've still distilled this into
like six lines or really four if I get
rid of the blank line so it's already
perhaps a bit tighter here here but
there's also it's tighter because
something really important historically
is missing what did I seem to Omit
altogether that we haven't really
highlighted yet
yeah yeah the main function is gone and
in fact maybe you took for granted that
it just worked a moment ago when I wrote
hello but I didn't have a main function
in hello either and this too is a
feature of python and a lot of other
languages as well instead of having to
adhere to these long-standing Traditions
if you just want to write code and get
something done fine just write code and
get something done without necessarily
all of the same boiler plate so whatever
is in your python file left indented if
you will by default is just going to be
the code that The Interpreter runs top
to bottom left to right well let me go
ahead now and run code like this let me
go ahead and open that back up my
terminal window run python of
calculator. piy and I'll do X is one y
is 2 and as you might expect it gives me
three slight aesthetic bug I put my
space in the wrong place here so that's
a new mistake let me fix that
aesthetically let me rerun python of
calculator. Pi type in one type in two
and voila there is now my same version
again but let me propose now that we get
rid of this training wheel we don't want
to keep taking one step forward and then
two steps back by adding these training
wheels so let me instead do this in my
version of calculator. suppose that we
take away already the training wheel
that is the cs50 library here and let me
instead then use just Python's built-in
function called input which literally
does just that it gets input from the
user and it stores it as before in X and
Y so this is not cs50 specific this is
real world Python Programming well let
me go ahead and run again python of
calculator. Pi and of course if x is one
and Y is 2 X + Y should of course still
be three
hm it's apparently 12 according to
python until cs50's Library gets
involved but does anyone want to
infer what's just went wrong
yeah exactly the input function by
Design always returns a string of text
after all that's what the human typed in
and even though yes I type the number
keys on the keyboard it's still coming
back is all text now maybe we should use
like a get in function well that doesn't
exist in Python all you can do is get
textual input a string from the user but
we can convert one to the other and so a
fix for this so that we don't accident
Al concatenate that is join X+ y
together would be to do something like
this let me go back to my python code
here and whereas in C we could
previously do type casting we could
convert one type to another that
generally wasn't the case when you were
doing something complex like a string to
an INT you could do a Char to an INT and
vice versa but for a string recall there
was a special function in the ctype
library called a to I like ask e to
integer that's uh that closest analog
here and in fact the way to do this in
Python would be to use a function called
int which indeed is the name of the data
type 2 even though I have not yet had to
type it and I can convert the output of
the input function automatically from a
string immediately to an INT and now if
I go back to my terminal window rerun
python of calculator. piy with one and
two for X and Y now I'm back in business
so that then is for instance what the
cs50 library does if temporarily this
week is it just deals with the
conversion for you and in fact bad
things could happen if I type the wrong
thing like dog or cat instead of a
number but we'll cross that bridge in
just a moment as well all right what if
we do something slightly different now
with our calculator instead of just
addition let me go ahead and do how
about uh div instead of addition let's
do division instead so Z equals x / y
thereby giving me a third variable Z let
me go ahead and run python of
calculator. piy again I'll type in one
I'll type in three this time and what
prog what problem do you think we're
about to
see or is it gone what happened when I
did this in C albeit with some slightly
more cryptic syntax when I divided one
number like one one divided by
three anyone recall
yeah yeah so it would round down to the
nearest integer whereby you experience
trunc so if you take an integer like one
you divide it by another integer like
three that technically should be
0.33333 infinitely long but in uh C
recall you truncate the value if you
divide an INT by an INT you get back an
INT which means you get only the integer
part which was the zero now python
actually handles this for us and avoids
the truncation but it leaves us still
with one other problem here which is
going to be for instance not necessarily
visible at a GL
this looks correct this has solved the
problem in C so truncation does not
happen the integers are automatically
converted to a float a floating point
value but what other problem did we trip
over back
in week uh
one what else got a little dicey when
dealing with simple
arithmetic anyone recall well the syntax
in Python's a little different but let
me go ahead and do this it turns out in
Python if you want to see more
significant digits than what I'm seeing
here by the default which is a dozen or
so let me go ahead and print out Z as
follows let me first print out a format
string because I want to format Z in an
interesting way and notice this would
have no effect on the difference this is
just a format string that for no
compelling reason at the moment is
interpolating z in those curly braces
using an F string or format string if I
run this again with one and three we'll
see indeed the exact same thing but when
you use an F string you indeed have the
ability to format that string more
precisely just like with percent F in
Python you could start to fine-tune how
many significant digits you see in uh p
in C rather in Python you can do the
same but the syntax is a little
different if you want the computer to
interpolate Z and show you 50
significant digits that is 50 numbers
after the decimal point syntax is
similar to C but it's a little different
you literally put a colon after the
variable's name 50 means show me the
decimal point and then 50 digits to the
right and the F just indicates please
treat this as a floating point value so
now if I rerun python of calculator. Pi
divide 1 by 3 unfortunately python has
not solved all of the world's problems
for us this again was an example of
floating point in Precision so that
problem is still latent so just because
the world has advanced doesn't
necessarily mean that all of our
problems from C have gone away there are
solutions using third-party libraries
for scientific calculations and the like
but out of the box floating point in
Precision is still an issue meanwhile
there was one other problem in C that we
ran into involving numbers and that was
this integer overflow recall that an
integer in C only took up what like 32
bits typically which meant you could
count as high as four billion or maybe
if you're doing positive and negatives
as high as two billion after which weird
things would happen the number would go
to zero or negative or just it would
overflow or wrap back around well
wonderfully in Python they did it at
least address this whereby you can count
as high as you want and python will just
use more and more and more and more bits
and bites to store really big numbers so
integer overflow is not a thing with
that said python is limited to how many
digits it will show you on the screen at
once as a string but mathematically your
math will be correct now so we've taken
a couple steps forward One Step sideways
but indeed we've solved some of our
problems here all right questions now
now on any of these examples thus
far
question all right well how about uh how
about another problem that we
encountered in C let's revisit it here
in python as well so let me go ahead and
on the left hand side here let me open
up a file called say compare let's see
uh how about a file called compare 3. C
on the left and let me go ahead and
create a new file on the right called
compare. Pi because recall that bad
things happened when we needed to
compare two values in C so on the left
here is a reminder of what we once did
in C whereby if we want to compare
values we can get an INT in C stored in
x a get int in C stored in y we then
have our familiar conditional logic here
just printing out if x is less than y or
not well we can certainly do the same
thing ultimately in Python by using some
fairly familiar syntax and let's just
demonstrate this one quickly let me go
over here too I'll do from cs50 import
uh get int even though I could do this
instead with the input function itself x
equals get int and I'll prompt the user
for that y equals get int and I'll
prompt the user for that after that
recall that I can say without
parentheses if x is less than y then
print out without the F uh X is less
than y then I can go ahead and say else
if x is greater than y i can print out
uh quote unquote X is greater than y if
you'd like to interject now what did I
screw
up anyone yeah L if right so L if L if x
is greater than y else this part's the
same print X is equal to Y so there's
not all that much new there's no New
Logic going on here but at least
syntactically it's a little cleaner
indeed this program is only 11 lines
long albeit without any comments let me
go ahead and run python of compare. Pi
let's see is 1 less than two indeed
let's run it again is 2 less than 1 no
it's greater than and let's lastly type
in one and one twice X is equal to Y so
we've got a pretty side by side onetoone
conversion here let's do something a
little more interesting then and see how
about I open instead something where we
actually compared for a purpose so if I
open up from last uh from earlier in the
course how about uh agree do C which
prompt the user to agree to something or
not and let me code up a new version
here called agree. pi and I'll do this
on the right hand side with agree. pi
but on gree do c on the left notice that
this is how we did this sort of yes no
thing in C we compared c a character
equal to single quotes y or equal to
single quotes little Y and then the same
thing for n now in Python this one's
actually going to be a little bit
different here let me go ahead and in
the python version of this let me do
something like this uh we'll use get
string uh actually no we'll just use
input in this case so let's do uh s
equals input and we'll ask the user the
same thing do you agree question mark
then let's go ahead and say if s equals
equals how about uh
y huh how do I do this well a few things
turns out I'm going to do this s equals
equals little y then I'm going to go
ahead and print out a agreed and L if s
equals equals capital N or S equals
equals lowercase n I'm going to go ahead
and print out not agreed and I claimed
for the moment that this is identical
now to the program on the right the
program on the left in C but what's
different so we're still doing the same
kind of logic these equal equals for
comparing for equality but notice that
nicely enough python got rid of the two
vertical bars and it's just literally
the word or if you recall seeing
Ampersand Ampersand to express a logical
and in C you can just write literally
the word and and so here's a hint of why
python tends to be pretty popular people
just like that it's a little closer to
English there's a little less of the
cryptic syntax here now this is correct
as this code will now work but I've also
used double quotes instead of single
quotes and I also omitted a few minutes
ago for my list of data types in Python
the word Char in Python there are no
chars there are no individual characters
if you want to manipulate individual
character you use a string that is to
say a stir of size one now in Python you
can use single quotes or double quotes
I'm deliberately using double quotes
everywhere just for consistency with how
we treat strings in C it's pretty common
though to use single quotes instead if
only because on most keyboards you don't
have to hold the shift key anymore I
mean humans have really started to
optimize just how quickly they want to
be able to code so using a single quote
tends to be pretty popular in Python and
other languages as well they are
fundamentally the same uh single or
double unlike in C where they have
meaning so this is correct I claim and
in fact let me run this real quick I'll
open up my terminal window here let me
get rid of the version and see run
python of agree. piy and I'll type in y
okay I'll run it again and type in
little Y and I'll stipulate it's going
to work for no as well but this isn't
necessarily the only way we can do this
there are other ways to implement the
same idea and in fact I can go about
doing this this instead let me go back
up to my code here and we saw a hint of
this earlier we know that lists exist in
Python and you can create them just by
using square brackets so what if I
simplify the code a little bit and just
say if s is in the following list of
values capital y or lowercase y it's not
all that different logically but it's a
little tighter it's a little more
compact so L ifs is in capital N or
lowercase n i can express that same idea
too so here again it's just getting a
little more pleasant to write code
there's less like hitting of the
keyboard you can express yourself a
little more succinctly and using the
keyword in Python will figure out how to
search the entire list for whatever the
value of s is and if it finds it it will
return true automatically else it will
return false so if I run agree. Pi again
and type in capital y or lowercase y
that still now works well I can typen
tighten this up further if I want to add
more features well what if I want to
support not just why Big Y and little y
but how about yes or yes or in case the
user's yelling or you know someone who
doesn't really isn't good with caps lock
types in yes wait a minute but it could
be weird like do we want to support this
or this I mean this this just gets
really tedious quickly combinatorically
if you consider all of these possible
permutations what would be smarter than
doing something like this if you want to
just be able to tolerate yes in any form
of capitalization like logically what
would be nice maybe whatever theut is
you justf over to all lower and then
exactly super common Paradigm why don't
we just force the users's input to all
lowercase or all uppercase doesn't
matter so long as we're self-consistent
and just compare against all uppercase
or all lowercase and that will get rid
of all of the possible permutations
otherwise now in C we might have done
something like this we might have
simplified this whole list and just said
let's say uh we'll do how about
lowercase so y or yes and we'll just
leave it at that but we need to force
now s to lowercase well in C we would
have used the ctype library we would
have done like two lower and called that
function passing it in although not
really cuz in C type those operate on
individual characters or chars not whole
strings we have actually didn't see a
function that could convert the whole
string in C to lowercase but in Python
we're going to benefit from some other
feature as well it turns out that python
supports what's called objectoriented
programming and we're only going to
scratch the surface of this in cs50 but
if you take a higher level course in
programming or CS you explore this as a
different Paradigm up until now in C
we've been focusing on what's called
really procedural programming you write
procedures you write functions top to
bottom uh left to right and when you
want to change some value we were in the
habit of using a procedure that is a
function you would pass something like a
variable into a function like to Upper
or to lower and it would do its thing
and hand you back a value well it turns
out that it would be nicer programming
wise if some data types just had
built-in functionality like why do we
have our variables over here and all of
our helper functions like two upper and
two lower over here such that we
constantly have to pass one into the
other it would be nice to sort of bake
into our data types buil-in
functionality so that you can change
variables using their own default be uh
buil-in functionality and so
object-oriented programming otherwise
known as oop is a technique whereby
certain types of values like a string
AKA stir not only have properties inside
of them attributes just like a struct in
C your data can also have functions
built into them as well so whereas in C
which is not objectoriented you have
strs and strs can only store data like a
name and a number when implementing a
person in Python you can for instance
have not just a structure otherwise
known as a class storing a name and a
number you can have a function like call
that person or email that person or
actual verbs or actions associated with
that piece of data now in the context of
strings it turns out that strings come
with a lot of useful functionality and
in fact this URL here which is in docs.
python.org which is the official
documentation for python you'll see a
whole list of methods that is functions
that come with strings that you can
actually use to modify their values and
what I mean by this is the following if
we go through the documentation poke
around it turns out that strings come
with a function called Lower and if you
want to use that function you just have
to use slightly different syntax than in
C you do not do to lower and you do not
say as I just did lower because this
function is built into s itself and just
like in C when you want to go inside of
a variable like a structure and access a
piece of data inside of it like name or
number when you also have functions
built into data types AKA methods a
method is just a function that is built
into a piece of data you can do s do
lower open pen closed pen in this case
and I can do this down here as well if
if s do lower in quote unquote uh n or
no the whole thing I can force this
whole thing to lowercase so the only
difference here now is in
object-oriented programming instead of
constantly passing a value into a
function you just access a function
that's inside of the value it just works
because of how the language itself is
defined and the only way you know that
these functions exist is the
documentation a Class A book a website
or the like questions now on this
technique all right I claim this is
correct now even though you've never
programmed most of you in Python before
not super well-designed there's an
subtle inefficiency now on lines three
and five together what's dumb about how
I've used lower might you
think
yeah yeah if you're going to use the
same function twice and ask the same
question expecting the same answer why
are you calling the function itself
twice maybe we should just store the
result in a variable so we could do this
in a couple of different ways we for
instance could go up here and create
another variable called T and set that
equal to s. lower and then we could just
change this to be T here but honestly I
don't think we technically need another
variable Al together here I could just
do something like this let's change the
value of s to be the lowercase version
thereof and so now I can quite simply
refer to S again and again like this
this reusing that same value now to be
sure I have now just lost the user's
original input and if I care about that
if they typed in all caps I have no idea
anymore so maybe I do want to use a
separate variable altogether but a
takeaway here too is that strings in
Python are technically what we'll call
immutable that is they cannot be changed
this was not true in C once we gave you
arrays in week two or memory in week
four you could go to town on a string
and change any of the characters you
want upper casing lower casing changing
it shortening it and so forth but in
this case uh this returns a copy of s
forced to lowercase it doesn't change
the original string that is the memory
the bytes in the computer's memory when
you assign it back to S you're
essentially forgetting about the old
version of s but because python does
memory management for you there's no
maloc there's no free python
automatically frees up the original
bytes like yees and hands them back to
the operating system for you all right
questions now on this
technique questions on
this in general I'll call out the python
documentation will start to be your
friend because in class we'll only
scratch the surface with some of these
things but in docs. python.org for
instance there's a whole reference of
all of the built-in functions that come
with the language as well as for
instance those with the string all right
well let me go ahead and before we take
a break let's go ahead and create
something a little familiar to based on
our week here in C let me propose that
we revisit those examples in involving
some meow so for instance when we had
our cat meow back in the first week and
then second in C we did something that
was a little stupid at first whereby we
created a file as I'll do here this time
called meow. p and if I want a cat to
meow three times I could run it once
like this little copy paste and now
python of meow. py and I'm done now
we've visited this example like two
times at least now in scratch it and see
it's correct I'll stipulate but what's
obviously poorly
designed what's the fault here
yeah it should just be a loop right like
why type it three times literally
copying and pasting is almost always a
bad thing except in C when you have the
function prototypes that you need to
borrow but in this case this is just
inefficient so what could we do better
here in Python well in Python we could
probably change this in a few different
ways we could borrow some of the syntax
we proposed in slide form earlier like
give me a variable called I set it to
zero no semicolon while I is less than
three if I want to do this three times I
can go ahead and print out meow and then
I can do i+ equals one and I think this
would do the trick python of meow. and
we're back in business already well if I
wanted to change this to a for Loop well
in Python it would be a little tighter
but this would not be the best approach
so for I in uh
012 I could just do print meow like this
and that too would get the job done but
to my to our discussion earlier this
would get stupid pretty quickly if you
had to keep enumerating all of these
values like what did we introduce
instead the the range function exactly
so that hands me back way more
efficiently just the values I want
indeed one at a time so even this if I
run it a third a third or fourth time
we've got the same result but now let's
transition to where we went with this
back in the day how can we start to
modularize this like just like it would
be nice I claimed if MIT had given us a
meow function wouldn't it be nice if
like python had given us a meow function
maybe less compelling in Python but how
can I build my own function well I did
this briefly with the spell checker
earlier but let me go ahead and propose
that we could Implement now our own
version of this in python as follows let
me go ahead and start fresh here and use
the keyword defa so this did not exist
in C you had the return value the
function name the arguments in Python
you literally say defa to define a
function you give it a name like meow
and now now I'm going to go ahead and in
this function just print out meow and
this lets me change it to anything else
I want in the future but for now it's an
abstraction and in fact I can uh move it
out of sight out of mind just going to
hit enter a bunch of times to pretend
like now it exists but I don't care how
it is implemented and up here now I can
do something like this 4 I in range of
three let me go ahead and not print meow
anymore let me just call meow and
tightening up my code further but I
think let's see python of meow. py this
is I think going to be the first time it
does not work
correctly okay so here we have sadly our
first python error and let's see the
syntax is going to be different from C
or clangs output traceback is like the
term of art here this is like a trace
back of all of the lines of code that
were just executed or really functions
you called the file name is
uninteresting this is like my codes
space specifically but the file name is
important here meow. py uh line two is
is the issue okay I didn't get very far
before I screwed up and then there's a
name error and you'll see in Python
there's typically these capitalized uh
keywords that hint at what the issue is
it's something related to names of
variables meow is not defined all right
you're programming python for the first
time you've screwed up you're following
some online tutorial you're seeing this
reason through it like why might meow
not be defined what can weer infer about
python how to troubleshoot
logically is it me ised after maybe is
it because meow is defined after you
know as smart as python seems to be Visa
VC they have some similar design
characteristics so let's try that so let
me scroll all the way back down to where
I move this earlier let me uh get rid of
it way down there I'll copy it to my
clipboard and let me just kind of hack
something together let me just put it up
here and let's see if this works so now
let me clear my terminal run python of
meow. okay we're back in business so
that was actually really good intuition
good debugging technique to sort of
reason through it now this is kind of
contradicting what I claimed back in
week one which was that you know the
main part of your program ideally should
just be at the top of the file like
don't make me look for it it's not a
huge deal with like a four-line program
but if you've got 40 lines 400 lines you
don't want like the juice juicy part of
your program to be way down here and all
of these functions way up here so it
would be nice maybe if we actually have
a main function and so it actually turns
out to be a convention in Python to
define a main function it's not a
special function that's automatically
called like in C but humans realized you
know what that was a pretty useful
feature let me Define a function called
main let me indent these lines
underneath it let me practice what I'm
preaching which is put the main code at
the top of the file and wonderfully in
Python now you do not need prototypes
there's none of that hackish copying and
pasting of the return type the name and
the arguments to a function like we
needed in C this is now
okay instead except for one Minor Detail
let me go ahead and run python of
meow. hopefully now I've solve this
problem by having a main function but
now nothing has happened all right even
if you've never programmed in Python
before What might explain this
behavior and how do I
fix again when you're off in the real
world learning some new language all you
have is deductive logic to debug yeah I
remember
right so the solution to be clear in C
was that we had to put the Prototype up
here otherwise we'd get an error message
in this case I'm actually not getting an
error message and indeed I'll claim that
you don't need the prototypes in Python
just not necessary because that was
annoying if nothing
else but what else might explain yeah
I'm
back yeah maybe you have to call Main
itself if main is not some some special
status in Python maybe just because it
exists isn't enough and indeed if you
want to call Maine the new convention is
actually going to be as the very last
line of your program typically to
literally call Main it's a little stupid
stupid looking but you know they made a
design decision and this is how now we
work around it python of meowy now we're
back in business but now logically why
does this work the way it does well in
this case top to bottom line one is
telling python to define a fun fun
called Main and then Define it as
follows lines two and three but it's not
calling main yet line six is telling
python how to define a function called
meow but it's not calling these lines
yet now line 10 you're telling python
call Main and at that point python has
been trained if you will to know what
main is on line one to know what meow is
on line six and so it's now perfectly
okay for Maine to be above meow because
you never called them yet you defined
defined and then you called and that's
the logic behind this any questions now
on the structure of this technique
here now let's do one more then recall
that the last thing we did in scratch
and in Python uh scratch and in C was to
actually
parameterize uh these same function so
suppose that you don't want Maine to be
responsible for the loop here you
instead want to very simply do something
like meow three times and be done with
it well in Python it's going to be
similar in spirit toy but again we don't
need to keep mentioning data types if
you want me now to take some argument
like a number n you can just specify n
as the name of that argument or you
could call it anything else of course
that you want you don't have to specify
int or anything else in your code now
inside of meow you can do something like
for I in let's say I definitely now
can't do this because like that would be
weird to start the list and end it with
n so if I can come back over here what's
the solution how can I do something n
times yeah using range so range is nice
cuz I can pass in now this variable n
and now I can meow whoops now I can
print out quote unquote meow so it's
almost the same as in scratch almost the
same as in C but it's a little simpler
and if now I run meow. P I'll have the
ability now to do this here as well all
right questions on any of this right now
we're sort of like taking the stroll
through week one we're going to
momentarily escalate things to look not
only at some of these basic but also
other features like we saw with face
recognition with the speller or the like
um because of how many of us are here we
have a huge amount of candy out in the
lobby so why don't we go ahead and take
a 10-minute break and we come back we'll
do even fancier more powerful things
with python in 10 all right so we are
back among our goals now are to
introduce a few more building blocks so
that we can solve more interesting
problems at the end much like those that
we began with you recall from a few
weeks ago we played with this sort of
two-dimensional Super Mario World and we
tried to print a vertical column of like
three or more bricks well let me propose
that we use this as an opportunity to
now Tinker with some of Python's more uh
useful more userfriendly functionality
as well so let me code a file called
mario. py and let's just print out like
that the equivalent of that vertical
column so it's of height three each one
is a hash so let's do for I in range of
three initially and let's just print out
a single hash and I think now python of
mario. py voila we're in business
printing out just that same pyramid
there or just that same column there
what if though we want to print a column
of like some variable height where the
user tells us how tall they want it to
be well let me go up here for instance
and instead how about we'll use um let's
do this how about uh from cs50
import how about the get in function as
before so it will deal with making sure
the user gives us an integer and now in
the past whenever we wanted to get a
number from a user we've actually
followed a certain Paradigm in fact if I
open up here for instance uh how about
Mario in how about Mario 1. C from a
while back you might recall that we had
code like this and we specifically use
the do while loop and see whenever we
want to like get something from the user
maybe again and again and again until
they cooperate at which point we finally
break out of the loop so it turns out
python does have while Loops does have
four Loops does not have do while loops
and yet pretty much anytime you've
gotten user input you've probably used
this Paradigm so it turns out that the
python equivalent of this is to do
similar in spirit but using only a while
loop and a common Paradigm in python as
I alluded earlier is to actually
deliberately induce an infinite Loop
while true capital T and then do what
you want to do like get an INT from the
user and prompt them for the height for
instance in question and then if you're
sure that the user has given you what
you want like n is greater than zero
which is what I want in this case cuz I
want a positive integer otherwise
there's nothing to print you literally
just break out of the loop and so we
could actually use this technique in C
it's just not really done in C you could
absolutely in C have done a while true
loop with the parentheses lowercase true
you could break out of it and so forth
but in Python this is like the python
way and this is actually a term of art
this way in Python is pythonic like this
is the way everyone does it quote
unquote doesn't mean you have to but
that's sort of the way like the cool
python programmers would Implement an
idea like this trying to do something
again and again and again until the user
actually cooperates but all we've done
is take away the do while loop but still
logically we can implement the same idea
now below this let me go ahead and just
print out for I in range of n this time
because I want it to be variable and not
three I can go ahead and print out the
hash let me go ahead and get rid of the
C version here open my terminal window
and I'll run again python of mario. py
I'll type in three and I get back those
three hashes but if I instead type in
four I now get four hashes instead so
the takeaway here is quite simply that
this would be the way for instance to
actually get back a value in Python that
is consistent with some parameter like
greater than zero how about this let's
actually uh practice what we preached a
moment ago with our meowing examples and
kind of factoring all this out let me go
ahead and Define a main function as
before let me go ahead and assume for
the moment that a get height function
exists which is not a thing in Python
I'm going to invent it in just a moment
and now I'm going to go ahead and do
something like this for I in the range
of that height well let's go ahead and
print out those hashes so I'm assuming
that get height exists let me go ahead
and Implement that abstraction so Define
a function now called get height it's
not going to take any arguments in this
design while true I can go ahead and do
the same thing as before assign a
variable n the return value of get int
prompting the user for that height and
then if n is greater than zero I can go
ahead and break but if I break here I
logically just like can see end up
executing below the loop in question but
there's nothing there but if I want get
height to return the height what should
I type here on line 14
logically what do I want to return to be
clear yeah so I actually want to return
n and here's another curiosity of python
Visa BC there doesn't seem to be an
issue of scope anymore right in C it was
super important to not only declare your
variables with the data types you also
had to be mindful of like where they
exist inside of those curly braces in
Python it turns out you can be a little
looser with things for better for worse
and so on line 11 if I create a variable
called n it exists on line 11 12 and
even 13
outside of the while loop so to be clear
in C with a while loop we would have
ordinarily had not the colon we would
have had the curly brace like here and
over here and a week ago I would have
claimed that in C N does not exist
outside of the while loop by nature of
those curly braces even though the curly
braces are gone python actually allows
you to use a variable anytime after you
have assigned it a value so slightly
more powerful as such how however I can
tighten this up a little bit logically
and this is true in C I don't really
need to break out of the loop by using
break recall that or know that I can
actually once I'm ready to go I can just
return the value I care about even
inside of the loop and that will have
the side effect of breaking me out of
the loop and also breaking me out of and
returning from the entire function so
nothing too new here in terms of C
versus python except for this issue of
scope and I indeed returned n at the
bottom there just to make clear that n
would still exist so either of those are
correct now I just have a Python program
that I think is going to allow me to
implement this same Mario idea so let's
run python of mario. and okay so nothing
happened uh python of mario.
py what did I do wrong yeah I have to
call Main so at the bottom of my code I
have to call Main here and this is a
stylistic detail that's been subtle um
generally speaking when when you are
writing in Python um there's not a cs50
style guide per se there's actually a
python style guide that most people
adhere to um it's and in this case
double blank lines between functions is
the norm I'm doing that deliberately
although uh it might otherwise not be
obvious but now that I've called main on
line 16 let's run mario. once more aha
now we get there now we see it type in
three and I'm back in business printing
out the values there
yeah
sure why do I need the if condition at
all why can't I just return n here as by
doing return n or if I really want to be
succinct I could technically just do
this the only reason I added the if
condition is because if the user types
in negative 1 -2 I wanted to prompt them
again and again that's all but that
would be totally acceptable too if you
were okay with that result instead well
let me do one other thing here to point
out why we are using get in so
frequently this new training wheel all
be it temporarily so let me go back to
the way it was a moment ago and let me
propose now to take away get int I
claimed earlier that if you're not using
get int you can just use the input
function itself from
python but that always returns a string
or a stir and so recall that you have to
pass the output of the input function to
an INT either on the same line or if you
prefer on another line instead but it
turns out what I didn't do was show you
what happens if you uh don't cooperate
with the user uh with the program so if
I run python of mario. now works great
even without the get int function and I
can do it with four still works great
but let me clear my terminal and be
difficult now as the user and type in C
for the height instead enter now we see
one of those tracebacks again this one
is different this isn't a name error but
apparently a value error and if I kind
of ignore the stuff I don't understand I
can see invalid literal for INT with
base 10 cat that's a super cryptic way
of saying that c a is not a number in
decimal notation and so I would seem to
have to somehow handle this case and if
you want to be more Curious you'll see
that this is indeed a trace back and um
C tends to do this too or the debugger
would do this for you too you can see
all of the functions that have been
called to get you to this point so
apparently my problem is initially in
line 14 but line 14 if I keep scrolling
is uninteresting it's main but line 14
leads me to execute line two which is
indeed in main that leads me to execute
line nine which is in get height and
okay here's the issue so the closest
line number to the error message is the
one that probably reveals the most line
nine is where my issue is so I can't
just blindly ask the user for input and
then convert it to an INT if they're not
going to give me an INT now how do we
deal with this well back in problem set
two you might recall validating that the
user typed in a number and using a for
Loop and the like well it turns out
there's a better way to do this in
Python and the are kind of there if you
want to try to convert something for a
number to a number that might not
actually be a number turns out Python
and certain other languages literally
have a keyword called try and if only
this existed for the past few weeks I
know but like you can try to do the
following with your code what do I want
to try to do well I want to try to
execute those few lines except if
there's an error so I can say except if
there's a value error specifically the
one I screwed up and created a moment
ago and if there is a value error I can
print out an informative message to the
user like not an integer or anything
else and what's happening here now is
literally this operative word try the
pro python is going to try to get input
and try to convert it to an in and it's
going to try to check if it's greater
than zero and then try to return it all
why all of three of those lines are
inside of indented underneath the tri
block except if something goes wrong
specifically a value error happens then
it prints this but it doesn't return
anything and because I'm in a loop that
means it's going to do it again and
again and again until the human actually
cooperates and gives me an actual number
and so this too is what the world would
call pythonic in Python you don't
necessarily rigorously try to validate
the users's input make sure they haven't
screwed up you honestly take a more
laxidasical approach and just try to do
something but catch an error if it
happens so catch is also a term of art
even though it's not a keyword here
except if something happens you handle
it so you try and you handle it it's
sort of best effort programming if you
will but this is baked into the mindset
of the Python uh programming community
so now if I do python of mario. py and I
cooperate works great as before try and
succeed three Works four works if though
I try and fail by typing in cat it
doesn't crash per se it doesn't show me
an error it shows me something more user
friendly like not an integer and then I
can try again with dog not an integer I
can try again with five and now it works
so we won't generally have you write
much in the way of these try except
blocks only because they get a little
sophisticated quickly but that is to
reveal what the get int function is
doing this is why we give you the
training wheels so that when you want to
get an INT you don't have to jump
through all these annoying Hoops to do
so but that's all the library is really
doing for you is just try and accept you
won't be left with any training wheels
ultimately questions now on getting
inputs and trying in this way
anything at all
yeah Tri block it say that oh you could
you put the condition outside of the tri
block short answer yes and in fact I
struggled with this last night when
tweaking this example to show the
simplest version I will disclaim that
really I should only be trying literally
to do the The Fragile part and then down
here I should be really doing what
you're proposing which is do the
condition out here the problem is though
that logically this gets messy quickly
right because except if there's a value
error I want to print out not an integer
I can't compare n against zero then
because n doesn't exist because there
was an error so it turns out and I'll
show you this this is now the advanced
version of python there's actually an
else keyword you can use in Python that
does not accompany if or L if it
accompanies try and accept which I think
is weirdly confusing a different word
would have been better but if you really
prefer I could have done this instead
dead and this is one of these design
things where like reasonable people will
disagree generally speaking you should
only try to do the one line that might
very well fail but honestly this looks
kind of stupid now it's just
unnecessarily complicated and so my own
preference was actually the original
which was yeah I'm trying a few extra
lines that really aren't going to fail
mathematically but it's just tighter
it's cleaner this way and here's again
the sort of like you know arguments
you'll start to make yourself as you get
more comfortable with programming you'll
have an opinion you'll disagree with
someone and so long as you can back your
argument up pretty
probably all right so how about we now
take away some piece of magic that's
been here for a while let me go ahead
and uh Delete all of this here and let
me propose that we revisit uh not that
vertical column and the exceptions that
might result from getting input but
these like horizontal question marks
that we saw a while ago so I want all of
those question marks on the same line
and yet I worry we're about to see a
challenge here because print up until
now has been putting new lines
everywhere automatically even without
those backslash NS well let me propose
that we do this for I in the range of
four if I want four question marks let
me just print four question marks
unfortunately I don't think this is
correct yet let me run python of mario.
and of course this gives me a column
instead of the row of question marks
that I want so how do we do this well it
turns out if you read the documentation
for the print function it turns out that
print not surprisingly perhaps takes a
lot of different arguments as well and
in fact if you go to the documentation
for it you'll see that it takes not just
positional arguments that is from left
to right separated by commas turns out
python has supports a fancier feature
with arguments where you can pass the
names of arguments to functions too so
what do I mean by this if I go back to
vs code here and I've read the
documentation it turns out that yes as
before you can pass multiple arguments
to python like this like hello comma
David comma me that will just
automatically concatenate all three of
those positional arguments together
they're positional in the sense that
they literally flow from left to right
separated by commas but if you don't
want to just pass in values like that
you want to actually print out as I did
before a question mark but you want to
override the default behavior of print
by changing the line ending you can
actually do this you can use the name of
an argument that you know exists from
the documentation set it equal to some
alternative value and in fact even
though this looks cryptic this is how I
would override the end of each line to
be quote unquote that is nothing because
if you read the documentation the
default value for this end argument does
someone want to guess is is back sln so
if you read the documentation you'll see
that back sln is the implied default for
this end argument and so if you want to
change it you just say end equals
something else and so here I can change
change it to nothing and now rerun
python of mario. and now they're all on
the same line now looks a little stupid
cuz I made that sort of week one mistake
where I still need to move the cursor to
the next line that's just a different
problem I'm just going to go over here
and print nothing I don't even need to
print back sln because if print
automatically gives you a backslash n
just call print with nothing and you'll
get that for free so let me rerun python
of mario. Pi and now it looks a little
prettier at the prompt and to be super
clear as to what's going on suppose I
want to sort of make an exclamation here
I could change the back sln default to
like an exclamation point Just for kicks
and if I run python of mario. py again
now I get this sort of you know
exclamation with question marks and
exclamation points as well so that's all
that's going on here and this is what's
called a named argument it literally has
a name that you can specify when calling
it in and it's different from positional
in that you're literally using the
name let me propose something else
though and this is why people kind of
like python there's just kind of cool
ways to do things that's kind of a you
know ver it's a three line verbose way
of printing out four question marks you
know I could certainly take the you know
shortcut and just do this but that's not
really that interesting for anyone
especially if I want to do it a variable
number of times but python does let you
do this if you want to uh multiply a
character some number of times not only
can you use Plus for concatenation you
can use star or an asterisk for
multiplication if you will that is
concatenation again and again and again
so if I just print out quote unquote
question mark Time 4 that's actually
going to be the tightest way the most
distinct way I can print four question
marks instead and if I don't use four I
use n where I get n from the user bang
like now I've gotten rid of the four
Loop entirely and I'm using the the star
operator to manipulate it instead and to
be super clear here in so far as python
does not have milock or free or memory
management that you have to do guess
what python also doesn't
have anything on your minds the past
couple of
weeks doesn't have pointers yes so
python does not have pointers which just
means that all of that happens for you
automatically underneath the hood Again
by way of code that someone else wrote
how about one more throwback with Mario
we've talked about in week one this sort
of two-dimensional structure where it's
like I claim like 3x3 a grid of bricks
if you will well how can we do this in
Python we can do this in a couple of
ways now let me go back to my mario. py
and let me do something like for I in
range of we'll just do three even though
I know now I could use get int or I
could use input and int and if I want to
do something two-dimensionally just like
in C you can Nest your for Loop so maybe
I could do 4J in range of three and then
in here I could print out a uh hash
symbol and then let's see if that gives
me nine total so if I've got a nested
Loop like this python of mario.
hopefully gives me a grid no it gave me
a column of
nine why
logically even though I've got my row
and my
columns
yeah yeah the line ending so in my row I
can't let print just keep adding new
line adding new lines so I just have to
override this here and let me not screw
up like before let me print one at the
end of the whole row just to move the
cursor down and I think now together now
we've got our 3x3 of course we could
tighten this up further like if I don't
like the nested loop I probably could go
in here and just print out for instance
a uh a brick times three or I could
change the three to a variable if I've
gotten it from the user so I can tighten
this up further so again just different
ways to solve the same problem and again
sort of evidence of why a lot of people
like python there's just some more
pleasant ways to solve problems without
getting into the weeds constantly of
doing things like like with um uh for
loops and wild Loops endlessly all right
well how about some other building
blocks lists are going to be so
incredibly useful in Python just as
arrays were in C but arrays are annoying
because you have to manage the memory
yourself you have to know in advance how
big they are or you have to use pointers
and malok or realloc to resize them like
oh my God like the past two weeks have
been painful in that sense but python
does this all for free for you in fact
there's a whole bunch of functions that
come with python that involve lists and
they'll ow us ultimately um to do things
again and again and again uh with uh
within the same data structure and for
instance we'll be able to get the length
of a list you don't have to remember it
yourself in a variable you can just ask
python how many elements are in this
list and with this I think we can solve
some some old problems too so let me go
back here to vs code let me close Mario
and give us a new program called scores.
piy and rather than show the C and the
python now let's just focus on Python
and in scores. C way back when we just
averaged like three test scores or
something like that 72 73 and 33 a few
weeks ago so if I want to create a list
in this python version of 72 73 33 I
just use my square bracket notation C
let you use curly braces if you know the
values in advance but Python's just this
and now if I want to compute the average
in pi in C recall I did something with a
loop I added all the values together I
then divided by the total number values
just like you would in grade school and
that gave me the average well python
comes with a lot of super handy
functions not just length but others as
well and so in fact if you want to
compute the average you can take the sum
of all of those scores and divide it by
the length of all of those scores so
python comes with length comes with sum
you can just pass in a whole list of any
size and let it deal with that problem
for you so if I want to now print out
this average I can print out average
colon and then I'll plug in my average
uh string for variable for interpolation
let me make this an F string so that it
gets formatted and let me just run
python of scores. Pi and there's my
average it's sort of rounding weird
because we're still vulnerable to some
floating point in Precision but at least
I didn't need loops and I didn't have to
write all this darn code just to do
something that you know Excel and Google
spreadsheets can just do like that well
python is closer to those kinds of tools
but more powerful and that you can
manipulate the data yourself how about
though if I want to um get a bunch of
scores manually from the user and then
sum them together well let's combine a
few ideas here how about this first let
me go ahead and uh import um the cs50 LI
get in function from the cs50 library
just so we don't have to deal with try
and accept or all of that and let me go
ahead and give myself an empty list and
this is powerful in py in C there's
really there's no point to an empty
array because if you create an empty
array with square bracket notation like
it's not useful for anything but in
Python you can create it empty because
python will grow and shrink the list for
you automatically as you add things to
it so if I want to get three scores from
the user I could do something like this
for I in range of three and then I can
grab a variable called score or anything
I could call get int prompt the human
for the score that they want to type in
and then once they do I can do this
thinking back to our objectoriented
programming capability now I could do
scores dot a pen
and I Canen that score to it and you
would only know this from having read
the documentation heard it in class in a
book or whatnot but it turns out that
just like strings have functions like
lower built into them lists have
functions like append built into them
that just literally appends to the end
of the list for you and python will grow
or Shrink it as needed no more Malo or C
or Realo or the like so this just
appends to the scores array the scores
list that score and then again and again
and again so the array starts at
sorry the list starts at size zero then
grows to one then two then three without
you having to do anything else and so
now down here I can compute an average
with the sum of those scores divided by
the length of the total number of scores
and to be clear length is the total
number of elements in the list doesn't
matter how big the values themselves are
now I can go ahead and print out an FST
string uh with something like average
colon average and curly braces and and
if I run python of scores. piy I'll type
in just for the sake of discussion the
three values I still get the same answer
but that would have been painful to do
in see unless you committ it in advance
to a fixed size array which we already
decided weeks ago was annoying or uh you
uh grew it dynamically using malok or
realloc or the like all right what else
can I do well there's some nice things
you might as well know exist um instead
of scores. aen you can do slight
fanciness like this like if you want to
append something to a list you can
actually do plus equals and then put
that thing in a a temporary list of its
own and just use what is essentially
concatenation but not concatenation of
strings but concatination of lists so
this new line six appends to the scores
list this tiny little list I'm
temporarily creating with just the
current new score so just another piece
of syntax that's worth seeing that
allows you to do something like that as
well all right well how about we go back
to strings for a moment and all these
examples as always are on the course's
website afterward suppose we want to do
something like converting characters to
uppercase well to be clear I could do
something like this let me create a
program called uppercase dop let me
prompt the user for a before string as
by using the input function or get
string which is almost the same and I'll
prompt the user for a string
beforeand then let me go ahead and print
out uh how about the keyword after
and then end the new line with nothing
just so that I can see before on one
line and after on the next line and then
let me do this and here's where python
gets pleasant too with loops for C in
before print c. uper n equals quote
unquote and then I'll print this here
all right that was fast but let's try to
infer what's going on so line one just
gets input from the user stores it in a
variable called before line two
literally just prints after but doesn't
move the new line to uh the cursor to
the next line what it then does is this
and in C this was a little more annoying
you needed a for loop with I you needed
array in uh notation with the square
brackets but python if you say four
variable in string so for c for
character in string Python's going to
automatically assign C to the first word
letter that the user types in then on
the next iteration the second letter the
third letter and the fourth so you don't
need any square bracket notation you
just you see and python will do it for
you and just hand you back one at a time
each of the letters that the user has
typed in so if I go back over here and I
run for instance python of uppercase
dopy and I'll type in how about uh David
in all lowercase and hit enter you'll
now see that it's all uppercase instead
by iterating over it indeed one
character at a time but we already know
thanks to object-oriented programming
strings themselves have the
functionality built in to not just
uppercase Single Character
but the whole string so honestly this
was a bit of a silly exercise I don't
need to use a loop anymore like in see
and so some of the habits you've only
just developed in recent weeks it's time
to start breaking them when they're not
necessary I can create a variable called
after set it equal to before do uper
which indeed exists just like lower
exists and then what I can go ahead and
print out is for instance uh let's get
rid of this print line here and do it at
the end after and print the value of
that variable so now if I rerun
uppercase Pi type in David and all
lowercase I can just uppercase the whole
thing all at once because again in C in
Python you don't have to operate on
characters individually questions on any
of these tricks up until
now now all right how about a few other
techniques that we saw and C that we'll
bring back now in Python so it turns out
in Python there are other librar you can
use two that unlock even more
functionality so in C if you wanted
command line arguments you just change
the proo the signature for main to be
void instead of void to be int argc
comma string argv Open brackets for an
array or Char star eventually well it
turns out in Python that if you want to
access command line arguments it's a
little simpler but they're tucked away
in a library otherwise known as a module
called CIS the CIS or system module now
this is similar in spirit to the cs50
library and that it's got a bunch of
functionality built in but this one
comes with python itself so if I want to
create a program like greet py in VSS
code here let me go ahead and do this
from the CIS Library let's import argv
and that's just a thing that exists it's
not built into main because there is no
main per se anymore so it's tucked away
in that library and now I can do
something like this if the length of
argv equals equals 2 well let's go ahead
and print out something friendly like
hello comma AR V bracket 1 and then
close quotes else if the length of RV is
not equal to two let's just go ahead and
print out hello world now at a glance
this might look a little cryptic but
it's identical to what we did a few
weeks ago when I run this python of
greet with no arguments it just says
hello world but if I instead add a
command line argument like my first name
and hit enter now the length of arv is
no longer one it's going to be two and
so it prints out hello David instead so
the takeaway here is that whereas in C
argv technically contained the name of
your program like hello or dog greet and
then everything the human typed Python's
a little different in that because we're
using The Interpreter in this way
Technically when you run python of greet
py the length of arv is only one it
contains only greet so the name of the
file it does not unnecessarily contain
python itself because what's the point
of that being there omnes it does
contain the number of words that the
human typed after python itself so argv
is length one here argv is length two
here and that's why when it did equal to
I saw hello David instead of the default
hello world so same ability to access
command line arguments add these kinds
of inputs to your functions but you have
to unlock it by way of using Arvy uh
instead in this way if you want to see
all of the words you could do something
like this uh just as if we combine ideas
here for I in range of how about length
of
arv then I can do this print argv
bracket I all right a little cryptic but
line three is just a for Loop iterating
over the range of length of argv so if
the human types in two words the length
of argv will be two so this is just a
way of saying iterate over all of the
words in arv printing them one at a time
so python of greet dopy enter just
prints out the name of the program
python of greet dopy with David prints
out greet dopy and then David I can keep
running it though with more words and
they'll each get printed one at a time
but what's nice too about Python and
this is the point of this exercise
honestly this looks pretty cryptic this
is not very pleasant to look at if you
just want to iterate over every word in
a list which argv is watch what I can do
I can do for ARG or any variable name in
ARG V let me just now print out that
argument I could keep calling it I but I
seems weird when it's not a number so
I'm changing to AR as a word instead if
I now do python of greet py it does this
if I do python of greet David it does
that again David ma it does that again
so this is again why Python's just very
appealing you want to do something this
many times iterate over a list just say
it and it reads a little more like
English and there's even other fanciness
too if I may it's a little stupid that I
keep seeing the name of the program
greet dopy so I it'd be nice if I could
remove that python also supports what
are called slices of arrays sorry slices
of lists even though I get the
terminology confused if Arvy is a list
then it's going to print out everything
in it but if I want a slice of it that
starts at location one all the way to
the end you can use this funky syntax in
between the square brackets which we've
not seen yet that's going to start at
item one and go all the way to the end
and so this is a nice clever way of
slicing off if you will the very first
element because now when I run greet doy
David men I should only see David and
men if I only want one element I could
do one to two if I want all of them I
could do zero onward I could give myself
just two of one of them in this way so
you can play with the start value and
the end value in this way to sort of
slice and dice these lists in different
ways that would have been a pain in see
just because we didn't really have the
built-in support for manipulating arrays
as cleanly as this all right just so
you've seen it too though this one is
less uh exciting to see live if I go
ahead and create a quick program here it
turns out there's something else in the
CIS Library the ability to exit programs
either exiting with status code one or
zero as we've been doing anytime
something goes right or wrong so for
instance Let Me Whip up a quick program
that just says if the length of cy.
argv uh does not equal two then let's y
at the user and say you're missing a
command line argument otherwise command
line argument and let's then return cy.
exit one else let's go ahead and
logically just say print a formatted
string that says hello as before cy.
arv1 now things look different all of a
sudden but I'm doing something
deliberately first let's see what this
does so on line one I'm importing not
argv specifically I'm importing the
whole CIS library and we'll see why in
second well it turns out that this Arvy
the CIS library has not only the Arvy
list it also has a function called exit
which I'd like to be able to use as well
so it turns out that if you import a
whole library in this way that's fine
but you have to refer to the things
inside of it by using that same
library's name and a DOT to sort of
namespace it so to speak so here I'm
just saying if the user types in does
not type in two words yell at them with
missing command line argument and then
exit with one just like in C when you do
exit one just means something went wrong
otherwise print out hello to this and
this is starting to look cryptic but
it's just a combination of ideas the
curly braces means interpolate this
value plug it in here cy. Arvy is just
the verbose way of saying go into the
CIS library and get the argv variable
therein and bracket one of course just
like arrays and C is just the second
element at the prompt so when I run this
version now python of exit. py with no
arguments I get yelled at in this way if
however I type in two arguments total
the name of the file and my own name now
I get greeted with hello David and it's
the same idea before this was a very
low-level technique but same thing here
if you do Echo dollar sign question mark
enter you'll see the exit code of your
program so if I do this incorrectly
again let me rerun it without my name
enter I get yelled at but if I do Echo
dollar sign question mark there's the
secret one that's returned again just to
show You parody with C in this case
questions now on any of these techniques
here all right how about something
that's a little more powerful too we
spent so much time in week zero and one
doing searching and then eventually
sorting in week three well it turns out
python can help with some of this too
let me go ahead and create a program
called names. py that's just going to be
an opportunity to maybe search over a
whole bunch of names let me go ahead and
import CIS and then just so I have
access to exit and let me go ahead and
create a variable called names that's
going to be a list with a whole bunch of
names uh how about Here Charlie and Fred
and George and Jenny and Percy and
lastly Ron so a whole bunch of names
here and you know it'd be a little
Annoying to implement code that iterates
over that from left to right and see
searching for one of those names in fact
what name well let's go ahead and ask
the user to input the name that they
want to search for so that we can tell
them if the name is there or not and we
could do this similar to C in Python
doing something like this so for n in
names where n is just a variable to
iterate over each name if how about the
name I'm looking for equals the current
name in the list AKA n let's print out
something friendly like found and then
let's do cy. Exit 0 to indicate that we
found whoever that is otherwise if we
get all the way to the bottom here
outside of this Loop let's just print
not found because if we haven't exited
yet and then let's just exit with one
just to be clear I can continue
importing all of CIS or I could do from
CIS import exit and then I could get rid
of CIS dot everywhere else but you know
sometimes it's helpful to know exactly
where functions came from so this two is
just a matter of style in this case all
right so let's go ahead and run this
python of names. piy and let's look for
like Ron all the way at the end you know
all right he's found and let's search
for someone outside of the family here
like herion not found okay so it seems
to be working in this way but I've
essentially implemented what
algorithm what algorithm would this seem
to be per lines seven and eight and nine
and
10 yeah so it's just linear search it's
a loop even though the syntax is a
little more succinct today and it's just
iterating over the whole thing well
honestly we've seen an even more tur way
to do this in Python and this again is
what makes it a more pleasant language
sometimes why don't I just do this
instead in of iterating one at a time
why don't I just say this let me go
ahead and change my condition to just be
How about if the name we're looking for
is in the names list we're done we found
it use the in preposition that we've
seen a couple of times now that itself
asks the question is something in
something else and python will take care
of linear search for us and it's going
to work exactly the same if I do python
of names. search for run it's still
going to find him and it's still going
to do it linearly in this case but I
don't have to write all of the lower
level code myself in this
case questions now on any of this the
code's just getting shorter and
shorter now what about uh let's see what
else might we have here how about this
it turns out let's go ahead and
Implement that phone book that we
started metaphorically with in the
beginning of the course let's code up a
program called phonebook dopy and in
this case let's go ahead and let's
create a dictionary this time recall
that a dictionary is a little something
that implements something like this like
a two column table that's got keys and
values words and definitions names and
numbers and let's focus on the last of
those names and numbers in this case
well I claimed earlier that python has
built-in support for dictionaries dict
objects that you can create with one
line I didn't need it for speller
because a set is sufficient when you
only want one of the keys or the values
not both but now I want some names and
numbers so it turns out in pyth python
you can create an empty dictionary by
saying dict open parenthesis close and
that just gives you essentially a chart
that looks like this with nothing in it
or there's more succinct syntax you can
alternatively do uh this with two curly
braces instead and in fact I've been
using a shortcut all this time when I
had a list earlier where my
variable uh was called scores and I did
this that was actually the shorthand
version of this hey python give me an
empty list so there's different Syntax
for achieving the same goal in this case
if I want a dictionary for people I can
either do this or more commonly just two
curly braces like that all right well
what do I want to put in this well let
me actually put some things in this and
I'm going to just move my Clos curly
brace to a new line if I want to
implement this idea of keys and values
the way you do this in Python is key
colon value comma key colon value so
you'd implement it more in code so for
instance if I want Carter to be the
first key in my phone book and I want
his number to be+ one 617495 1000 I can
put that as the corresponding value the
colon is in between both are strings or
stirs so I've quoted both deliberately
if I want to add myself I can put a
comma and then just to keep things
pretty I'm moving the cursor to the next
line but that's not strictly required
aesthetically it's just good style and
here I might do+ 1 949 468 uh
2750 and now I have a dictionary that
essentially has two rows here David uh
Carter and his number and David and his
number as well and if I kept adding to
this this call this chart would just get
longer and longer suppose I want to
search for one of our numbers well let's
prompt the user for the name for whose
number you want to search by getting
string or you know what we don't need
the cs50 library let's just use input
and prompt the user for a name and now
we can use this super syntax and just
say if name in people print the format
added string number colon and here we
can do this people bracket name okay so
this is getting kind of cool kind of
quickly kind of confusingly so let me
run this python of phone
book. let's type in Carter and indeed I
see his number let's run it again with
David and I see my number here so what's
going on well it turns out that a
dictionary is very similar in spirit to
a list it's actually very similar in
spirit to an array in C but instead of
being limited to keys that are numbers
like bracket 0o bracket 1 bracket two
you can actually use words and that's
all I'm doing here on line eight if I
want to check for the name Carter which
is currently in this variable called
name I can index into my people
dictionary using not a number but using
literally a string the name Carter or
David or anything else to make this
clear too notice that I'm at the moment
you using this format string which is
adding some undue complexity but I could
clarify this perhaps further as this I
could give myself another variable
called number set it equal to the people
dictionary indexing into it using the
current name and now I can shorten this
to make it clear that all I'm doing is
printing the value of that and in fact I
can do this even more cryptically if I
this would be weird to do but if I only
ever want to show David's phone number
and never Carter's I can literally quote
unquote index into the people dictionary
because now when I run this even if I
type Carter I'm going to get back my
number instead but that's all that's
happening if I undo that because that's
now a bug but I index into it using the
value of name dictionaries are just so
wonderfully convenient because now you
can associate anything with anything
else but not using numbers but entire
keywords instead so here's how if in
spell we gave you not just words but
hundreds of thousands of definitions as
well you could essentially store them as
this and then when the human wants to
look up a definition in a proper
dictionary not just for spellchecking
you could index into the dictionary
using square brackets and get back the
definition in English as well
questions on this
yeah
location a really good question so how
to summarize how is python finding that
name within that dictionary this is
where honestly speller in pet 5 is what
Python's all about so you have struggled
are struggling with implementing your
own spell checker and implementing your
own hash table and recall that per last
week the goal of a hash table is to
ideally get constant time access not
something linear which is slow and even
better than something uh uh logarithmic
like log base 2 of n so Python and the
really smart people who invented it they
have written the code that does its best
to give you constant time searches of
dictionaries and they're not always
going to succeed just as you and your
own problem set probably going to have
some collisions once in a while and
start to have chains of length lists of
words but this is where again you defer
to someone else someone smarter than you
someone with more time than you to solve
these problems for you and if you read
Python's documentation you'll see that
it doesn't guarantee constant time but
it's going to ideally optimize the data
structure for you to get as fast as
possible and of all of the data
structures um like a dictionary a
hashtable is really like the Swiss army
knife of computing because it just lets
you associate something with something
else and even though we keep focusing on
names and numbers that's a really
powerful thing because it's more
powerful than lists and arrays which are
only numbers and something else now you
can have any sorts of relationships
instead all right let me show a few
other examples before we culminate with
some more powerful techniques in pythons
thanks to libraries how about this
problem we encountered in week four
which was this let me code up a program
called again compare. Pi here but this
time compare to Strings and not numbers
so let me for instance do uh get one
string from the user called s just for
the sake of discussion let me get
another string from the user uh called T
so that we can actually do some
comparison here and if s equals equals T
let's go ahead and print out that
they're the same else let's go ahead and
print out that they're different so this
is very similar to what we did in week
four but in week four recall we did this
spef specifically because we had
encountered a problem for instance if I
run whoops
uh if I
run what's going on uh input
T come
on oh the okay wow okay long day all
right if I run the proper command python
of compare. py then let's go ahead and
type in something like cat in all
lowercase cats in all lowercase and
they're the same uh if though I do this
again with dog and dog they're the same
and of course cat and dog they're
different but does anyone recall from
two weeks ago when I typed in my name
twice both identically capitalized what
did it say that they were in
fact different and why was that like why
were two strings in C different even
though I typed literally the same
thing two different places in memory so
each string might look the same
aesthetically but of course was stored
elsewhere in memory and yet python
appears to be using the equality
operator equals equals like you and I
would expect as humans actually
comparing for us Char by Char in each of
those strings for actual equality so
this is a feature of python in that it's
just easier to do and why well this
derives from the reality that in Python
there are no pointers anymore there's no
underlying memory management it's not up
to you now to worry about those lower
level details the language itself takes
care of that for you and so similarly if
I do this and don't ask the user for two
strings but just one and then I do
something like this how about give
myself a second variable T set it equal
to s.
capitalize which note is not the same as
upper capitalize by Design per Python's
documentation will only capitalize the
first letter for you I can now print out
say two F strings here what the value of
s is and then let me print out with
another F string what the value of t is
and recall that in C this was a problem
because if you capitalize s and store it
in t we accidentally capitalized both s
and t but in this case in Python when I
actually run this and type in cat in all
lowercase the original s is unchanged
because when I use capitalize on line
three this is indeed capitalizing s but
it's returning a copy of the result it
cannot change S itself because again for
that technical term s is IM mutable
strings once they exist cannot be
changed themselves but you can return
copies and modified mutated copies of
those same strings so in short all of
those headaches we encountered in week
four are now solved really in the way
you might expect and here's another one
that we dwell on in week four with the
colored uh liquid in glasses let me code
up a program called swap. pi and in
swap. pi let me set x equal to 1 y equal
to 2 and then let me just print out an F
string here so how about X X is this
comma Y is that and then let me do that
twice just for the sake of demonstration
and in here recall that we had to create
a swap function but then we had to pass
it in by reference with the Amper sand
and like oh my God like that was kind of
peak complexity and see well if you want
to swap X and Y in Python you could do X
comma yal y comma X and now python of
swap whoops python of
swap. and there we go all of that's
handled for you sort of like a shell
game without even a temporary variable
in mind so what more can we do here how
about a few final building blocks and
these related now to files from that
week four suppose that I want to save
some names and numbers in like a a CSV
file comma separated values which is
like a very lightweight spreadsheet well
first let me create a uh phonebook CSV
file that just has name comma number as
like the first row there but after after
that I'm going to go ahead now and code
up a phonebook dopy program that
actually allows me to add things to this
phone book so let me split my screen
here so that we can see the old and the
new and down here in my code for phone
book. in this new and improved version
I'm going to actually import a whole
other Library this one called CSV and
here too especially for people in data
science and the like really like being
in a manipulate files and data that
might very well be stored in
spreadsheets or csvs comma separated
values which we we saw briefly in week
four in phonebook then it suffices to
just import CSV after reading the
documentation therefore because this is
going to give me functionality in code
related to CSV files so here's how I
might open a file in Python I literally
call open it's not fop now it's just
open and I open this file called
phonebook.com
going to open it in a pend mode not
right where it would change the whole
thing I want to append new line at a
time uh after this I want to get maybe
how about a name from the user so let's
prompt the user for some input for their
name and then let's prompt the user for
a number as well using input prompting
for number all right and now this is a
little cryptic and you'd only know this
from the documentation but if you want
to write line rows to a CSV file that
you can then view in Excel or the like
you can do this give me a variable
called writer but I could call it
anything I want let me use a CSV do
writer function that comes with this CSV
Library passing in the file this is like
saying hey python treat this open file
as a CSV file so that things are
separated with commas and nicely
formatted in rows and columns now I'm
going to do this use that writer to
write a row well what do I want to write
I want to write a short list namely the
current name and the current number to
that file but I don't want to use FR
printf and percent s and all of that
stuff that we might have had in the past
and now I just want to close the file
let me reopen my ter teral let me run
python of phone book. and let me type in
how about David and then +1
949468 2750 and hold crossing my fingers
watching the actual CSV at top left my
code has just added me to the file and
if I were to run it again for instance
with Carter in plus1 617495 1000
crossing my fingers again we've updated
the file and it turns out there's code
now via which I can even read that file
but I can first tighten this up just so
you've seen it it turns out into python
it's so common to open files and close
them you know humans make mistakes and
they often forget to close files which
might then end up using more memory than
you intend so you can alternatively do
this in Python so that you don't have to
worry about closing files you can use
this keyword instead you can say with
the opening of this file as a variable
called file do all of the following
underneath so I'm indenting most of my
code I'm using this new python specific
keyword called wi and this is just a
matter of saying with the following
opening of the file do those next four
lines of code and then automatically
close it for me at the end of the
indentation it's a minor optimization
but this again is sort of the pythonic
way to do things instead how else might
I do this too well it turns out that the
code I've written here on line n
especially is a little fragile right if
any human opens the spreadsheet the CSV
file in Excel Google spreadsheets Apple
numbers and maybe like moves the columns
around just because maybe they're
fussing they SA it and they don't
realize they've now changed my
assumptions I don't want to necessarily
write name and number always in that
order CU what if someone screws up and
flips those two columns by literally
dragging and dropping so it turns out
that instead of using a list here we can
use another feature of this Library as
follows instead of using a writer
there's something called a dictionary
writer or dict writer that takes the
same argument as input the file that's
opened but now the one difference here
is that you need to tell this dictionary
writer
that your field names are name and
number and let me close the CSV here
name and number are the names of the
fields The Columns in this CSV file and
when it comes time to write a new row
the syntax here is going to be a little
uglier but it's just a dictionary the
name I want to write to the dictionary
is going to be whatever name the human
typed in the number that I want to write
to the the CSV file is going to be
whatever the number the human typed in
but what's different next about this
code is by simply using a dictionary
writer here instead of the generic
writer now the columns can be in this
order or this order or any order and the
dictionary writer is going to figure out
based on the first line of text in that
CSV where to put name where to put
number so if you flip them no big deal
it's going to notice oh wait the columns
changed and it's going to insert the
columns correctly so just again another
more powerful feature that lets you
focus
on lets you focus on real work as
opposed to actually uh getting tied up
in the weeds of writing code like this
otherwise questions on this one as well
but what we will do now is come full
circle to some of the more uh
sophisticated examples with which we
began and I'm going to go back over to
my own Mac laptop here where I've got my
own terminal window up and running and I
was just going to introduce a couple of
final libraries that really speak to
just how powerful python can can be and
how quickly you can get up and running
to be fair can't necessarily do all of
these things in the cloud like in code
spaces because you need access to your
own speakers or microphone or the like
so that's why I'm doing it on my own Mac
here but let me go ahead and open up a
program called
speech. and I'm not using VSS code here
I'm using a program called VI that's
entirely terminal window based but it's
going to allow me for instance to import
the python text to speech version three
Library I'm going to give myself a
variable called engine that's going to
be set equal to the python text to
speech 3 libraries init method which is
just going to initialize this library
that relates to text to speech I'm going
to then use the engines say function to
say something like how about hello comma
world and then as my last line I'm going
to say engine. runand wait capitalized
as such to tell my program now to run
that speech and wait until it's done all
right I'm going to save this file I'm
going to run python of speech. py and
I'm going to cross my fingers as always
and hello world all right so now I have
a program that's actually synthesizing
speech using a library like this how can
I now modify this to be a little more
interesting well how about this let me
go ahead and prompt the user for their
name like we've done several times here
using Python's built-in name function
and now let me go ahead and use a format
string in conjunction with this Library
interpolating the value of name there
and at least if my name is somewhat
phonetically pronounceable let's go
ahead and run python ofp
speech. type in my name and hello David
okay it's a sort of weird choice of
inflection but we're starting to
synthesize voice not unlike Siri or
Google assistant or Alexa or the like
now we can maybe do something a little
more advanced too in addition to
synthesizing speech in this way we could
synthesize for instance uh an actual
graphic let me go ahead now and do
something like this let me create a
program called
qr. I'm going to go ahead and import a
library called OS which gives you access
to operating system related
functionality in Python I'm going to
import a library I've pre-installed
called QR code which is a
two-dimensional barcode that you might
have seen in the real world I'm going to
go ahead and create an image variable
using this QR code library's make
function which per its documentation
takes a URL like one of cs50's own
videos so we'll do this with YouTube uh
/xv f
zj5
p g g0 so hopefully that's the right
lecture and now we've got image. saave
which is going to allow me to create a
file called qr. ping think back now on
problem set 4 and how painful it was to
save files we'll just use the save
function now in Python and save this as
a ping file portable Network graphic and
then lastly let's just go ahead and open
uh the with the command open qr. ping on
my Mac so that hopefully this just
automatically opens all right I'm going
to go ahead and just double check my
syntax here so that I haven't made any
mistakes I'm going to go ahead and run
python of qr. enter that opens up this
let me go ahead and zoom in if you've
got a phone handy and you'd like to scan
this code
here whether in person or
online I apologize you won't appreciate
it amazing okay and lastly let me go
back into our speech example here uh
create a final ending here on our final
moments and how about we just say
something like this was cs50 like this
let's go ahead here fix my
capitalization just for tidiness get rid
of the name and now with our final
flourish and your introduction to python
equipped here we go this was cs50 all
right we'll see you next
[Applause]
time
[Music]
all right this is cs50 and this is
already week seven and this is the week
where we'll continue where we left off
with python introducing you to a bit
more syntax and capabilities of the
language so you can solve like
interesting problems but a lot of those
problems increasingly are now going to
involve data in some form after all if
you think of most any website or mobile
app uh or uh process nowadays that
involves solving problems it almost
always involves some amount of data and
often data at scale lots and lots of
data and so what we're going to see
first today is that yes you can use
Python to solve all the problems past
that we've seen and also some data
specific ones but sometimes it's just
going to be annoying it's going to be a
little painful it's just going to be
more work than you might like to just
get to some answer and so today we'll
too introduce you to a new language
called SQL structured query language and
this is a language that wur is actually
much smaller relatively speaking than C
and python it sort of does less but it
does it really well and it's a language
for querying databases storing data in
it updating it inserting it deleting it
and so much more and it's the kind of
Technology that's used nowadays in
indeed web apps and mobile apps data
science analytics and and so much more
it's really good at storing lots and
lots of data now this is yet another
language and believe it or not next week
we'll introduce you to three more
languages HTML and CSS which are not
technically programming languages
they're all about Aesthetics and markup
of information but also JavaScript which
is in fact a programming language but
the goals here in cs50 really are going
to be to empower you to program more
generally and indeed when you're out
there in the real world some years from
now invariably there's going to be some
new other popular language out there and
hopefully in this week and next week and
Beyond among the goals is not just to
teach you these languages specifically
but again like how to teach yourself the
future languages that we've not even
heard about just yet so with that said
let's begin with a survey of sorts if
you go to this URL on your phone or
laptop cs50. l/f favorites a very simple
Google form awaits you that's just going
to ask you a couple of multiple choice
questions so go to cs50.
l/f favorites and that should lead you
to a Google form that looks a little
something like this asking you first as
of now in week seven what is your
favorite language among those options
here and then further down one more
question if you think back on problem
sets 0 through six what was if any your
favorite uh problem set problem be it in
scratch or C or python so answer those
two
questions and in a moment I'll flip over
to my screen here where you'll see and
anyone who's used Google forms knows the
spreadsheet that's collecting now this
data um Microsoft Office 365 can do the
same if you use one of those forms and
what you see here now is a spreadsheet
in Google Sheets enumerating all of the
audience's questions language is in
column B problem is in column C and each
row represents one student who has
responded uh a few of you were super
eager for class today at 8:33 a.m.
eastern time 10:32 11:10 okay so now
we're getting into the actual class time
here and if I scroll down we'll probably
see few dozen couple hundred Answers by
now and yeah so we're getting a whole
lot of answers here and I'm seeing some
patterns emerge but but it's not
necessarily obvious to the human eyes
what those patterns are now of course
you can use Google spreadsheets you can
like highlight the data and you can
create charts magically out of it but
you can only do what Google lets you do
with the data and same thing for
Microsoft Excel or apple numbers but
wouldn't it be nice to just be able to
manipulate the raw data relatively
simple though it is to just answer
questions about the data Maybe long-term
create your own charts customize it just
the way you want rather than be holding
to like software that's off the shelf
like this well how could we go about
doing this well let me propose that we
treat this data set now as what we're
going to call for now a flat file
database we'll see today that there's
fancier databases but the simplest
database in the world is really just
like a CSV file and we saw that a couple
of weeks ago in C we wrote a bit of C
code that used F printf to write data to
a file using commas as the separator we
didn't really do much more with csvs at
the time though because it's really
annoying painful timec consuming not fun
to use see for something like that
because of malok and memory and all that
stuff but with python it's going to be
much easier and so anytime you have
access to some data set where you can
just like download it to your own Mac or
PC or your Cloud environment it's sort
of a candidate for now writing code to
do something with the data Maybe analyze
it right away if it's been human inputed
manually maybe you have to clean it up
by doing a lot of find and replace but
not with your keyboard but rather with
code and so let me go ahead and do this
let me go back to my uh Google sheet
here that has all of the data that's
come in now and let me go ahead and
download this via uh the file menu
here and let's see download and you can
see a whole bunch of options of most
formats might be familiar but today
we'll focus just on this one comma
separated values or CSV that's going to
go ahead and download it on my Mac here
into my own downloads folder and now I'm
going to go ahead and do this let me go
ahead and pull up VSS code in the cloud
here and if you've never done this
before there's a couple of ways to do it
but the simplest way to upload a file to
your codes space so to speak is just a
sort of drag and drop that's going to
magically upload it to the server there
and we'll see that one it has a very
long file name which I'm I'm actually
going to clean this up because that's
going to be very tedious to type in my
code so I could either rightclick of of
course up here but I'm going to use my
Linux command so let's move this file
called cs50 2022 something or other and
let's just name it more simply
favorites. CSV so all lowercase no
spaces sort of good Basics and let me go
ahead now and open up this file with
code favorites. CSV I'll close my file
explorer and we'll see exactly the same
data as before but not quite as pretty
as Google Sheets makes it be rather we
see here that I still have three columns
timestamp language problem and then all
of the values down below including the
timestamps and the answers therefore but
it doesn't have proper columns it just
has commas separating them now we could
very easily write python code just like
we wrote code to manipulate files like
this either to write or read but in
instead let's do something that's a
little more pleasant which is indeed in
the form of python so python actually
comes with Native support for csvs it
has indeed a package called CSV that
just lets you read and write and do a
whole bunch of useful stuff when it
comes to CSV files so let's go ahead and
do something with this file let me go
back here to VSS code I'm going to close
favorites. CSV for now but just remember
in your mind that timestamp was the
first column language was the second
column and problem was the third and
notice because we're using commas they
don't again line up perfectly but that's
not a problem there are two commas in
every line presumably and I'm going to
go ahead and now create a file called
how about uh favorites. piy so that I
can start writing some code to
manipulate this data and let's do
something simple let's just write a
simple program in Python that opens this
file reads it and prints something out
just as like a safety check that I know
what I'm doing even though it's not
going to be useful so in Python if you
want CSV support you import CSV and that
gives you access to all the magical
capabilities thereof let me now go ahead
and use this technique to open a file in
Python which is similar in C but with
python I'm going to do this the keyword
with I'm going to open a file called
favorites. CSV which was the shorter
name I gave it this is optional but just
for explicitness I'm going to open it in
read mode explicitly just like f open
took a second argument as well and I'm
going to name this file once open quite
simply file though I could call it
anything I want and now it's just an
open file so far as python knows at this
moment it's just text or better yet it's
just zeros and ones if you want this
python package called CSV to actually do
something useful with it you have to
load this file now into the library and
the simplest way to do this is to give
myself like a variable called reader
because I want to read this file though
this too I could call anything else I'm
going to then set that equal to the
return value of a function called CSV do
reader and I pass to that per the
documentation the open file so step one
I open the file and this just gives me
me access to the bytes there in step two
now with csvreader tells the python
package called CSV to do something
useful with it and start analyzing the
commas and uh allow me to uh parse it
further so let's go ahead and do this
let me go ahead now and within this Loop
let's say this with sorry within this
open file let's do this for every row if
you will or line in the file AKA reader
let's go ahead and print out now just
how about Row Bracket one now what's
going on here well it turns out if you
read the documentation for the CSV
reader function what it hands you back
is essentially this special object so to
speak that allows you to treat it as
though it's just a really big list of
lines from the file AKA reader so by
saying for Row in reader this is a way
more succinct way of saying uh give me
the first line in the file plus plus
give me the second line in the file Plus
plus and so forth that we would have
done what much more mechanically in C
this is just much more pythonic and
English friendly if you will so in every
iteration of this Loop row is going to
contain all of the data from the current
row but better yet what the reader
function does for me is it hands me each
row not just as a big string or Stir of
text in Python it gives me what
apparently based on the syntax on line
six any Instinct yeah it's giving me
back indeed a list and I'm I presume the
visual clue for you was the fact that
we're using square brackets here and
indeed Row Bracket one is going to be
not the first but the second element in
that list and so just take a guess when
I run this code in a moment What's going
to get printed the timestamp the
language or the
problem the yeah oh the language the
language because it's the second column
that is in the file delimited by those
those commas so let me go ahead and do
this let me clear my terminal down here
here let me run python of favorites.i
and enter and there's everything it was
super fast but there's a really long
list here and in fact if I increase the
size of my terminal and start scrolling
up you'll just see all of the raw data
now this isn't that useful yet I could
have just glanced at the CSV but clearly
now I have the ability to open the file
parse it so to speak that is break it up
into its constituent parts and do
something with specific Parts therein
all right so if I want to do this a
little more pleasantly though let me at
least least make this semantically a
little cleaner and you know what just
for clarity let me just give myself a
variable it's not strictly necessary but
I know that this is the favorite uh for
instance uh language so let's just call
it favorite set it equal to Row Bracket
1 and now just to be more explicit in my
code even though again we don't need the
variable per se this codee's of course
going to do the same thing it's just
using an additional variable called
favorite if I go down here scroll up run
the program again I get back the exact
same data but this is a stepping stone
to something that's even more powerful
about python support for CSV files is
that you don't have to just treat the
return value as a list with zero and one
and two so just thinking intuitively
here why is this maybe not the best
design to hand you the programmer back
the data in a list that's numerically
indexed with
012 it clearly works but critique this
what could go wrong what's a little
poorly designed yeah you have to always
remember what
are
yeah exactly so if yeah so it's up to
you to repeat it's up to you to remember
like what column the data is actually in
and you know God forbid you're you're
collaborating with someone else on the
spreadsheet you know you've if you've
used Google spreadsheets you can move
columns around maybe just because you
want to visually reorganize things and
if you do this and then someone else
downloads that same data all of their
code is going to break so that's just
really bad design it's fragile just
because it's you're sort of on the honor
System that one means the data that you
want so wouldn't it be nice if we could
be a little more explicit well recall
that the very first line in this file is
actually this and I paused the output
this time so that we can see more
optionally I just reran favorites St pi
and notice one of these things is not
like the other every output was either
scratch or C or python except for this
first one why am I seeing the word
language
here where did language come from you
didn't have the ability to manual input
oh no where did it come from
yeah yeah the header the very first row
in the file which by human convention
generally just defines what the columns
represent so that there's some human
useful information there now that's not
really intended to be part of my output
at the moment so there is a way to skip
this if you want to skip the first row
you can actually do something like this
you can say next row and that will just
ignore that row so that I'm starting
really with the every row thereafter but
there's a better way to handle this than
that that will get rid of the row in the
output but let me go ahead and use a
different feature of the CSV package
that's just going to make this a little
cleaner Al together so let me clear my
terminal window here let me undo this
next thing that I just added and instead
of using a reader let me go ahead and
use a dictionary reader abbreviated dict
reader that's going to now return me the
equivalent of all of the rows one at a
time so I can still call it Reader just
as before but as the name implies what
this reader is going to return is not a
list after list after list but a
dictionary a dictionary a dictionary and
remember a dictionary is just a
collection of key value pairs so what
does that mean what are the keys what
are the values well now that I'm using a
dictionary reader I can actually do this
instead of sort of on the honor System
remembering that I want column one I can
treat row now not as a list but as a
dictionary and that means I can go in
here and say quote unquote language and
we saw that back in week six python
allows you to index into dictionaries
using square bracket notation in strings
or stirs on the inside just like lists
allow for numbers but this now I think
is going to be a little more robust if I
run this again python of favorites. py
all of that worked out fine and let me
pause the output to by using this
program called more now I don't even see
the header so now whoever works it uh
with python wrote the code for this
package to just analyze that first line
of code use the header as you just
called it as the keys and then every
time you iterate through this Loop it
updates the values the values the values
but the keys stay the same any questions
then on this
technique spiced to say this would be
painful in C
yes
Associated exactly so the keys are
always going to be quote unquote
timestamp uh Pro language and problem
but on each iteration of this Loop here
uh the row is going to contain a
different row of values different row
values different row values so you're
going to get back one dictionary for
every student who submitted the Google
form if you will while iterating through
it there all right so once we have this
ability here why don't we go ahead and
transition
into how about not just using that
dictionary reader which makes the code a
little more robust because now if you
move the columns around no big deal it
doesn't matter if the numeric indices
change you can still use those keywords
instead well let's actually analyze the
data now I'm just spitting it out which
is not solving any problems for anyone
so let's go ahead and and count the
popularity of scratch C and Python and
see what everyone's uh been thinking
here all right so how might I do this
well let me go ahead and do this up here
before I start iterating let me give
myself let's say three variables and to
keep things simple I'll say one variable
called scratch set it equal to zero for
zero students so far C is going to equal
zero and python is going to equal zero
there's a slightly prettier way of doing
this just because this is like three
lines of code to do something very
simple you could alternatively in Python
but not C do scratch comma C comma
python equals 0 comma 0 so kind of
slightly more elegant just to fit it all
into one line but now let's just do
something more interesting on line seven
I'm still going to figure out what the
current favorite language is and now I'm
just going to do some conditional checks
How about if that favorite equals equals
quote unquote scratch let's go ahead and
increment Scratch by one we can't do
plus plus in Python but we can do plus
equals 1 how about L if favorite equals
equals c then let's do C+ equal 1 L and
not we could do else this is actually a
good design question should I do else
should I do L if any instincts here
yeah yeah really good instincts just in
case someone goes and adds another
language to the form next week because
we're obviously going to introduce
another language today you don't want
your code to now artificially inflate
the scores for python just because
you're conflating multiple languages
together so the more defensive sort of
better way to write this code I agree
would be L if favorite equals equals
python then let's go ahead and increment
python plus equals 1 and if there's a
new language next week we're obviously
going to have to update the code but at
least we're not miscounting we're just
missing the new language so I think
that's slightly more robust all right
now at the very bottom of this program
and outside of the loop when I'm all
done counting let me go ahead and print
out using some f strings how about the
total number of people who uh whose
favorite is scratch so this is just uh
week six F string syntax let me go ahead
and print out another F string for C and
I'm of course putting the variables in
curly braces all lowercase but the
English words I'm doing capitalization
for Let's do an final one with f uh
python colon and then in curly braces
python close quote and I think I'm done
so let me just hide my terminal for a
second here's the total program same
stuff as before open favorites. CSV open
it further with the dictionary reader to
do that processing for us initialize
three variables to zero just so we have
something to count with and then iterate
over the file row by row and this is
just some sort of week one style
conditional logic albe it in Python
counting things all right so how can we
now execute this let me go back to my
terminal python of favorites.i and here
we go uh as of today everyone who's
reporting in live via the Google form
their favorite languages are
interesting that's pretty interesting
too after just one week of python no
less so but scratch is a healthy
Contender there a lot of C so a pretty
good mix here so is this going to be the
best way to write this program long term
well as you noted if there's a new
language next week this week we're going
to have to constantly update this and
here's where you should let your mind
wander to like the future like if we
have a fourth language fifth language
6th sth eth which aspect here might kind
of have some code smell to it like this
probably isn't the best design to set us
up for the
future what might be better than this
yeah add language line yeah we have to
keep adding a language to line five and
okay not a big deal we could add like
SQL today and maybe JavaScript next week
but you know anytime a a line of code a
line of logic is just going to kind of
grow out of control and we've had this
chat a couple of times with different
syntax there's probably a better way
than that so let's do that instead of
using these individual variables we
could make maybe use a list but a list
would be a little confusing because like
what does braet zero mean what is
bracket 1 bracket two but a dictionary
recall is like this Swiss army knife of
data structures whereby you can
associate anything with anything else
keys with values so I dare say a cleaner
way to solve this problem that sets us
up for Less work or confusion later
would be to create like a new variable
called counts if that's what we're doing
counting things up and just set it equal
to an empty dictionary and you can
literally say adct with the open
parenthesis closed parenthesis nothing
or the more pythonic just use open and
Clos curly braces with nothing inside
that gives me an empty dictionary just
like square brackets gives me a list now
my logic down here has to change a
little bit but what's nice is I don't
need one conditional for every language
because again if we have a fourth a
fifth a sixth that chunk of code is also
going to grow a bit out of control too
so I can get rid of this here and what I
think I'm going to do is say this
whatever the current favorite is from
the current Row in the file why don't we
go into our counts variable at that key
and again favorite is a variable it's
not quote unquote favorite it's going to
be scratch or C or Python and then why
don't we go ahead and just increment
whatever the value of that count is at
that key now this is technically bugy
we're really close but there is a
bug does anyone want to conjecture what
the bug is
yeah a good question that answers my
question in uh nonetheless so no like
the magic you describe will not happen
and to repeat the the hypothesis will
this automatically create a key for
every uh language that we try plugging
into those square brackets short answer
no odds are this is going to create a
key error one of those traceback error
messages that you've probably seen by
now either in class or in problem sets
whereby if scratch hasn't appeared in
the dictionary before or C or python
like then the dictionary has no clue
what you're talking about so I think we
actually still need some conditional
logic but not that's going to grow
longer and longer with each language
what I think we probably want to do is
this if the current favorite is in the
counts dictionary and this is the
pythonic way of just saying is this key
in this dictionary then go ahead and
safely do count favorite plus equals 1
else to your conjecture now else what do
I want to do counts
favorite
equals yeah one so initialize a brand
new key to a brand new value of one
because I'm obviously just seen this
language otherwise increment again and
again and now down here I just need to
tweak my syntax a little bit I don't
need to print out all of these things
one at a time manually I can actually
get away I think with another loop at
the very bottom here so how about I do
this for each favorite in those counts
and this is again the pythonic way to
iterate over all of the keys in a
dictionary go ahead and print out using
an F string whatever the current
favorite is scratch or C or Python and
then a colon and then figure out what
its count is and you can do that by
going into the counts dictionary looking
at the favorite key and get back its
value so close my curly braces I close
my quotes and even though this looks
ugly at the moment now this is much more
dynamic because if we go and add SQL to
the CSV file tomorrow where we add
JavaScript next week this will just work
it will keep working now automatically
all I change is the Google form not my
actual code all right let's try python
of favorites.i cross my fingers as
always and there now is the data as of
now questions on this code here
yeah really good good question what if
you wanted to print it in a particular
order uh well I could give you a couple
of solutions like if you want to print
it out in it's already coincidentally in
alphabetical order so you got that for
free although that's just by chance here
but there is a way to do this and let me
propose that we go down here to my Loop
and I explicitly use a function you
might not have seen in Python yet but
it's literally called sorted which is
going to take either a list or in this
case a dictionary and by default sort it
by key alphabetically now if my
intuition is correct this is not going
to change the output because it's
already alphabetical but if you read the
documentation for the sorted function it
takes multiple parameters potentially
some of which are named parameters and
so you can actually do this if you want
to sort the counts but you want to
reverse the order for whatever reason
here so that it's reverse alphabetical
order now let me go ahead and rerun this
and I'll keep the previous output on the
screen enter and now it's backwards uh
alphabetically if you will other
questions on this here
here no how about then how about then we
transition
to changing sorting by value and let me
this is going to escalate a little
quickly briefly but then we'll we'll
tone it down again notice that right now
this is indeed sorting by key what if
especially if I have lots of data it'd
be nice to make like a top 10 list or in
this case a top three list and actually
see in order of the counts the values uh
what these popular ones are so it's not
C python scratch it should ideally be
python then C then scratch because of
the values and the magnitude thereof so
how can I do this well it turns out
there's another key another uh parameter
that you can pass to the sorted function
that is typically implemented as a
function itself and so I'm going to go
ahead and do this I'm going to
temporarily Define a function called get
value just to make my life easier and
this get value function is going to take
I'll say a language par parameter and
then all I'm going to do is return
whatever the count is of that language
so out of context this is just a super
simple function that you hand it a
language like scratch or C or python
it's just going to tell you what the
count is thereof in that uh in that
dictionary called counts but what I can
do now down here in my newly introduced
call to sorted is I can tell it what to
use as its key instead of using
literally the key scratch C python I can
sort of override that behavior and say
you know what to figure out what to sort
by go ahead and call this function
called get value notice that I have not
put parentheses after get value because
I don't want to call get value right
then and there I want to pass the get
value function as itself in argument to
the sorted function so that the sorted
function written years ago by the people
at python can call my version of get
value again and again and again when
they try to sort sort this actual data
so now if I add that and I leave reverse
equals true let's see what happens
python of favorites. py enter and now I
get my top 10 or in this case top three
list and if I had more sophisticated
data with like more columns Al together
that I actually care about I could even
sort this more uh powerfully as well but
let me clean this up a little bit just
so you've seen it even though we won't
use these that often in cs50 until the
end of the class will they come up again
technically this is a little bit H this
isn't necessarily the best design to
spend all this time implementing a
function and then only use it in one
place in general we've argued that H you
don't necessarily need a variable if
you're only going to use it in one place
you don't really need a function if
and here we kind of have a good
candidate for that and so it turns out
in Python if you don't want to bother
creating a function just to use it once
you can create what's called an
anonymous function AKA a Lambda function
like the lamb Lambda symbol familiar and
a Lambda function the syntax is a little
strange looking but you say this you
literally say Lambda you literally then
say the name of the argument that you
want this Anonymous function with no
name to take then you have a colon and
then quite simply you write what you
want the return value of this function
to be you don't even say return
literally these Lambda functions are
meant to be used super turly so that you
can in one line Express something like
this and I admit this looks more cryptic
I think than the previous version but as
you get more comfortable with python or
other languages that support this
feature it allows you to not bother with
lines of code like that and just tighten
up your code a little bit so this line
here lamba language colon counts
language is the oneline version of this
and you don't even need to bother
picking a name for it Lambda tells
python I didn't waste any time thinking
of a name for this
function so questions then on this
technique technique of using python to
analyze data like
this any
questions we're almost done with python
questions no okay so why don't we make
things a little more interesting because
we had a much juicier data set with the
problems that we've assigned over the
past several weeks why don't we go ahead
and quite simply you know I think we
wrote pretty darn good code here so I
think we can pretty much just change a
bit of it to say let's see if I don't
want language I want problem and if I
want to sort by not language but problem
I think that's it I think if I didn't
Overlook something here just by changing
what column I'm reading the data from
and then just to be consistent renaming
my variables just so I know what I'm
looking at what will this program now do
after those minor
changes what will I see when I run
this
what would be the first thing I see when
I run
this tough crowd today yes problem yeah
the problem this the top problem so the
most popular problem which I'm a little
worried it might be hello or just
scratch but let's go ahead and see so
let me go ahead and open my terminal
window I'll even maximize my terminal
window so we can see a lot let me go
ahead and run python of favorites. py
I'm going to go ahead now and cross my
fingers that I didn't mess up and hit
enter and okay great we peaked early so
scratch was the most popular program
according to the data at the time I
downloaded it I'm sure other votes have
come in since filter uh in week four was
tied then with tan as well Mario is a
close third there and so forth so this
is helpful for us on staff that uh not
so much love down here at the bottom of
the list so it was a bunch of code to
write but now that we've written it in
this very versatile Dynamic way it's
pretty good for just like crunching data
and doing some analytics but it's still
a decent number of lines to have had to
write manually and this is where
sometimes it isn't necessarily the right
tool for the job but rather the job that
uh but rather a candidate for using some
other language alog together especially
when it's not just a one-time program
that you run and you want to see the
answer what if you want to take input
from the user and ask uh answer
questions dynamically like a mobile app
would like a website would like
Microsoft Excel or apple numbers or
Google Sheets would for for you well
let's make one final change for now to
this version of the program and actually
take in some user input so besides just
loading all of the data into memory
let's go ahead and down below here not
just print out the top 10 list if you
will but prompt the user for their
favorite so I'm going to use Python's
input function and I'm just going to
prompt them with favorite quote unquote
like tell me what your favorite problem
what problem uh rather uh you interested
in and now let me go ahead and say if
that favorite is in the counts variable
so you didn't type in something random
that we didn't actually assign as a
problem then let me go ahead and print
with a format string whatever that
favorite is of yours and show you the
actual popularity thereof by indexing
into counts using that favorite as the
key and printing this so now it's a
dynamic program it doesn't dump all of
the data and all of the summations
rather it's going to allow me to see
what my choice of favorite is and I'm
going to go ahead and say uh let's see
I'm a fan of Mario here so enter and
indeed we see the same value we saw a
moment ago but just for Mario but the
point now is that one all of this is
possible two it's way easier and more
pleasant than this would have been in C
this is still only 15 lines of code and
in C again there's the memory management
there's the iterating over the strings
trying to find the commas there's just a
lot more work but honestly even when you
just want to answer a question like this
in Excel in Apple Numbers Google sheets
you know generally you can just
highlight things you can click a button
and boom you get your answer for
summation or Max or Min or any of those
sort of Basics wouldn't it be nice if we
weren't taking a step backwards as
programmers and being sort of more
powerful and yet we now have to do more
of the work so maybe sometimes Python's
not or any language is not the best tool
for the job and that's going to now
allow us to introduce more generally
something called a relational database
graduating from Mere flat file databases
like text files or binary files in which
all of your data is stored to something
more proper but first
questions really good question to
reiterate if I were to is this case
sensitive so if I were to type in Mario
in all lowercase and hit enter I
actually get no such response now that
might be acceptable because the problem
technically what is a capital M but
that's a little uh ridiculous to be that
pedantic about the input so how could we
solve
this any tips for how we can make this a
little more robust
yeah okay
yeah yeah so we could use a few
different functions one of which is
called title which will change it to
title case where it capitalizes like in
most English sentences the first letter
of that sentence we could use capitalize
we could use upper we could use lower
but indeed we could just decide how we
want to standardize the capitalization
either uppercase lowercase or some
combination thereof and just make sure
that you change the counts themselves
make sure that you do the same to
favorite and make sure that maybe you
keep a backup of the data if you want to
show the original version that came from
the CSV without presuming to just
capitalize everything for the user but
indeed that would be the most common
scenario you just make things case
insensitive when doing those matches
other questions now on python before we
leave it behind for the coming
week all right well then let's introduce
these relational databases so relational
database is what like every is a super
popular way of storing lots of data like
this is what the Twitter's of the world
the Googles of the world the metas of
the world use to store some of their
data at scale there are alternatives to
relational databases um indeed today
we'll talk about a language called SQL
there's so a movement if you will or an
alternative generally called No SQL
which is just the opposite you don't use
SQL there are things called
objectoriented databases and the like
but if you've ever heard of MySQL or
postgress SQL or uh Microsoft SQL server
or Oracle or Maria DB or a bunch of
other products both free and Commercial
this is what they're talking about
databases that are designed to store
lots of data and what's nice about
relational databases is that they're
really similar to the spreadsheets with
which you were presumably familiar long
before today's class so a relational
database is going to store as you'll see
all of the data in rows and columns now
the terminology will thereafter be a
little different instead of having
sheets you're going to have tables but
those tables are still going to have
rows and columns and you're going to
have even more control over the
performance of your data when you start
to access it using this structured query
language or SQL this is a language you
can use for web apps mobile apps uh a
lot of analysts would sit down and their
Mac or PC and actually ask questions of
data to get back the answer and
wonderfully even though there will be
some new syntax today SQL really just
does four basic things crud is the sort
of crude acronym here crud is a way of
remembering that a relational database
supports ultimately creating data
reading data updating data and deleting
data so even if you're feeling like wow
this is a lot of new syntax which it
isn't relative to our past languages the
only things you're doing really are
creating dat data reading data updating
and deleting the same now a little
confusingly in SQL the corresponding
functions or commands that exist that
map to crud are actually this so it's
still create but there's another one
called insert uh it's not read which is
more of the computer scientist way of
saying it but select which is a little
more explicit like select data you care
about update is still update delete is
still delete but there's another command
called drop which lets you drop that is
delete entire tables as well so you can
create tables using syntax that's
generally going to look like this you'll
say create table you'll give the name of
the table uh which you can call almost
anything you want but generally all
lowercase no spaces is best then in
parentheses you can specify a comma
separated list of the columns that you
might want in this table so this is the
code equivalent in the SQL language of
like manually opening Google Sheets or
Excel or numbers and like clicking in
the top left cell and like typing
timestamp and then in the next typing
language and then in the third typing
problem this is the way to sort of
Define what your headers are if you will
in a spreadsheet but now it's called a
table now we won't use this command
manually first let's do something a
little simpler we're going to start off
by just importing this data ourselves
and I'm going to go ahead and do this
let me go back to vs code here I'm going
to leave behind favorites. py for now
because now we're going to transition to
this other language called SQL and to do
this I am going to create a new database
file and I'm going to do so using a
command called SQL light 3 which is just
the third version thereof and I'm going
to give the database a name of
favorites. DB there's different
conventions but this is one of the most
common when I hit enter this is going to
create for me a new empty database just
like opening an Untitled spreadsheet in
Excel Google Sheets or Apple Numbers I'm
being prompted do I want to create
favorites. DB I'll hit y for yes okay
we're up and running now you're going to
notice a different prompt I'm not in my
Linux prompt per se which is always the
dollar sign I'm now inside of the
program called SQL light and we're going
to use SQL light SQL light 3 as just an
interactive way for now of playing with
SQL code at the end of today we'll show
you how you can use SQL in Python code
so that you still write python code to
do whatever you want but you can talk to
databases using Python and this is
exactly how web apps mobile apps work
for instance on iOS uh and an i phone an
iPad or the like if you want to store
data it's very often stored in a SQL
database as we're about to do um but you
might use a language called Swift or
objective c and same exists in the world
of Android using Java or cotlin or
something else to query the database so
we're going to see SQL in isolation for
now like an analyst might just use at
their Mac or PC but we're going to tie
it together by Day end so at this
terminal uh SQL light let me go ahead
and execute uh this command first I'm
going to first put SQL light into CSV
mode because I'm going to cut some
Corners initially and I'm just going to
automatically import all of the data
that was submitted via that Google form
which I exported as a CSV and uploaded
to my code space and I'm just going to
automatically say turn this CSV file
into a SQL database for me just so I
don't have to figure out what those
create table commands are so to do this
I'm going to say mode CSV so that SQL
light knows that this is the command uh
knows that this is a CSV file it's
literally mode so the dot comes before
the keyword there and now I'm going to
say do import and then the name of the
file I want to import which is
favorites. CSV and now the name of the
table that I want to create with that
data and just for consistency I'm going
to call it favorites I could change
these things to be anything I want but
I'm going to do that and voila nothing
seems to have happened but just like in
C and in Python in Linux when nothing
seems to happen that's usually a good
thing it means I didn't mess up so if I
want to see what just happened there's
this other command and these commands
that start with dots these are SQL light
specific which is indeed a lightweight
version of SQL they're not SQL per se so
if you're using Oracle or something else
like that you're not going to use these
exact commands you'll see the ones we
use in just a moment and here's the
first when I type schema the schema of a
database is the design of the database
what are the tables what are the columns
and all of that so when I type schema
this actually in this case shows me that
create table command that was
automatically run for me by just doing
this import line once I get more
comfortable with SQL I could literally
type this out myself or use some program
to generate that as well but what it's
creating for me is this create table if
it doesn't exist even though it's more
tur than that I want to create a table
called favorites and then the columns
for that table are going to be timestamp
which is going to be text comma language
which is also going to be text comma
problem which is also going to be text
that was just inferred very trivially by
the do import command to just figure out
that yes just give me a three column
database table based on the Google
form okay questions on this these are
commands you run once to get up and
running you don't run these commands
frequently but we have them on the slide
just for reference all right so now
let's do something a little more
interesting I'm going to clear my SQL
light terminal here but I'm still in SQL
light I'm going to now use some of my
first SQL commands which recall were uh
were among them uh select so crud c r UD
D the r was select this is maybe the
most common the most useful the most
powerful thing to use with a SQL
database selecting data to answer
questions akin to the ones we were
trying to answer with python this is the
general syntax anytime you want to
select data from a SQL database you
literally say select you then specify
the column or columns that you want to
select data from you literally write the
word from and then you specify the name
of the table you want to get that data
from semicolon in this case everything
that's in capitals here is a sequel
keyword strictly speaking you don't have
to capitalize things but we would
encourage you to do so stylistically and
especially as you're learning and even
as you're writing it it just helps to
distinguish SQL from like words you
chose like the names of the columns and
the data there're in so uh do adopt
early on this convention so let me go
back now to my code space here I'm
running my terminal window with SQL
light 3 inside of it suppose that I just
want to get all of the data from the
favorites table which was automatically
imported let's do this select I want
everything well I can do timestamp comma
language comma problem but you know what
here's a uh convenience already if you
want everything there's what's called a
wild card character in SQL which is just
a star in asterisk which means give me
every column without my knowing even
what they're called let me go ahead now
and say from favorite it's semicolon and
this is the SQL way of opening the
database iterating over every row
they're in printing out every row
therein done so those three steps which
was like nine lines of python code give
or take earlier is now one line of SQL I
hit enter there is all of the data so I
see now all of the data just outputed as
a CSV here but it's not the CSV file
it's now actually the table and in fact
just for good measure let me do this CU
you'll see the behavior a little
different the next time we open the file
I've just exited out of SQL light 3 I'm
going to rerun it but I'm not going to
reimport the data or do anything like
that because my file now exists in fact
let me take one step back if I type LS
at my Linux prompt there's my favorites.
py from before there's my favorites. CSV
from before and here's a third file that
I did create a moment ago when I first
ran SQL light 3 so the data is
persistent it's not using Ram or memory
anything I do now is save there so let's
go ahead and rerun SQL light 3 with the
same file but I'm not going to I don't
have to reort everything because the
file already exists let me now do that
same thing again select star from
favorites to get all of the data and
what you'll see now is the same data but
it's a little prettier now because I
reran it I effectively disabled CSV mode
this time and what I'm now seeing is the
entire contents of this database table
called favorit now there's nothing new
here but you're just seeing now like an
asky or Unicode version of all of the
same data from that database well
suppose I want to get a subset of the
data well let me clear my screen and
just like in Linux I can hit contrl L
just to clean things up aesthetically
suppose I want to get just the languages
so I could do select language from
favorites and this will now select not
all three columns AKA star this will
only select the language column and all
of the data they're in if I hit enter
voila now I just see those there no time
Stamps no problems it's just a slice of
the table if you will all right not that
interesting still still because it's
just a big column of data but now things
get more interesting it turns out in SQL
that there are functions that come with
this language just like C just like
python in SQL some of the more useful
ones some of the simpler ones are these
here average count distinct lower Max
Min upper which pretty much uh do what
they say and count is a particularly
useful one let's start with that you
know it's a reasonable question to be
asked uh how many people submitted the
Google form by the time I actually
downloaded the CSV well why don't we go
ahead and do this let me go back to VSS
code here in my terminal window let me
select not star but the count of star so
give me the count of the rows that are
being returned from the database called
uh the database table called favorites
now when I hit enter I'm not going to
get all the data I'm just going to get
simply a number 430 rows came back so
that's pretty good I now know how much
data is in there well what languages
were in there well I could do select
language from favorit just as before but
that's not that useful especially if I'm
inheriting the data like I'm the analyst
who's been handed a data set by my boss
and they want me to like crunch some
numbers okay I could like load this into
Excel I could sort it but you can use
SQL now to answer pretty basic questions
too if you want to select the distinct
languages in the data set because you
didn't you weren't privy to the Google
form let me go ahead and select only the
distinct languages from the favorites
table and now I hit enter and I get back
a much more succinct answer just the
three languages in question not really
that useful since I created the Google
form but certainly if you're inheriting
data from someone else you've just
downloaded a data set at least now I'm
arguably wrapping my mind around what's
going on now this is not necessary for
such a small data set but I can combine
these things select the count of the
distinct languages in this data set
called favorites and now I should get
back what
answer so hopefully indeed an answer
called three and what you're getting
back notice aesthetically too is like a
mini temporary table when I asked for uh
just the distinct languages what SQL
hands me back is this temporary table in
memory that has one column called
language and then two row uh three rows
now this is not saved anywhere it's just
executed ephemerally like this but
that's why it's depicted in this way
what you're getting is subsets of your
data smaller tables containing some of
your data and same thing down here this
is like a crazy long
uh column name you can rename it if you
really want uh but uh that's all we're
seeing there and in fact if that's a
little ugly we can actually Alias These
Things N is a common uh name for a
variable a number in any programming
language so I can actually alas this to
be a column called n hit enter and now
I'm getting a tiny tiny table whose
column is called n that just has the one
value
there all right questions on
these application of these functions
here no questions
yeah say a little louder as oh as as
literally in English so name this column
rename this column as this technically
it creates an alias for the column so
that's all
yeah exactly distinct will operate on
whatever you handed in parentheses and
get rid of all of the duplicates giving
you back just the unique
correct other questions here
yeah good question when you define an
alias like n which I just did does it
become like a variable you can reuse
short answer no in this case but you can
reuse it within your same query even
though these these queries are getting a
little longer admittedly statements that
they are uh you can actually reuse n in
even longer queries so later in your
query and we'll see a few that are start
to going to start to grow in length so
it's a a nice way of nicknaming things
just to be a little more tur in your
query so we can transition to some of
these more sophisticated queries because
it turns out there's some other uh
techniques we can introduce as well here
are some other keywords in SQL and again
even though like this is another list of
things there's only four things
fundamentally we're doing creating
reading updating and deleting data these
are just allowing us to like fine-tune
how we do it exactly so where is going
to allow us to filter data as we'll do
in just a moment like select data where
this conditional is true uh like is
going to be an alternative to an equal
sign so instead of looking for exactly
scratch or exactly python or exactly C
you can look for something like dot dot
dot and it can be a little bit of a
fuzzier match if you will uh with other
characters as well order by is going to
deal with sorting limit is going to just
let me limit the total number of rows
that come back to one or 10 or finite if
I don't want to see all 400 plus rows
all at once because I'm just trying to
wrap my mind around it and group by is
best shown by example so let's play with
just a couple of these as well let me go
back to vs code here I'll clear my
screen I'm still in the same SQL light
instance and let's count how many of you
likeed C without writing python code as
before so let me go ahead and select the
count of the rows from favorites where
the language in each row equals c and
the convention in SQL light is to use
single quotes anytime you're surrounding
a string that's meant to represent a
literal piece of text uh as opposed to C
which was double quotes or python which
was either so this is selecting the
count of rows from favorites table where
the language in question is C enter and
this gives me 98 notice though if I omit
that predicate like we did before you'll
get back the total number of rows that
were in the table so where is what's
called a predicate that just allows me
to filter things just like an if
condition or the like in a language that
we've seen before you can be a little
more specific like how many people
really liked C and the Mario program uh
problem specifically well let's do this
uh let's go ahead and do select the
number of rows from the favorites table
where the language is C and so it's uh
still literally the word ands and or
just like in Python but not like in C uh
and
equals Mario so let's see if there's any
fans of both C and the Mario problem and
three of us really like those two things
together in this case all right what
else can we do well more compelling
might be to see kind of like in Python
for each language what was the
popularity thereof and at the moment we
don't really have a way of doing that
except in Python where we had the loop
and we had those variables with the
dictionary that did all that counting
for us you know totally doable but
tedious especially if your job is to
analyze data my God like even writing 15
lines of code to answer simple questions
is kind of ridiculous SQL can do better
for us so let me go ahead and do this
let me go ahead and select every
language and the count thereof from the
favorites table but this time Group by
language so this was another one of the
keywords that we can use in this
abbreviated list of extra features of
SQL and this one's a little takes a
moment to wrap your mind around but this
is going to give me a two column
temporary table where the First Column
is a language and the second column is
the count thereof from this data set and
group by language just means that only
show me scratch once only show me c once
only show me python once that is group
all of the identical values together but
keep track of how many of them there are
and so now if I go over to SQL light and
I hit enter now I have in SQL version
the exact same output that I had from
python that took me what 15 plus lines
before now we're down to just one
because SQL structured query language is
all about constructing queries like this
to answer questions and get back answers
quickly if we want to clean this up a
little bit you asked earlier about
sorting order well we can do that too
there's another uh key phrase we can use
here we can order by the count of those
rows and then run that query here so now
unfortunately they're from smallest to
biggest but we can reverse that it turns
out and my query is starting to wrap
here I'll I'll zoom out for a moment if
you want to order by count the default
is in ascending order abbreviated ASC if
you want to reverse the sort in SQL
instead of using reverse equals true
like we did in Python you say DC for
descending order and now we get almost
the same output but flipped in Reverse
so it's just a lot faster to answer
questions once of course you get some
muscle memory and some comfort with it
well what else can I do you know what if
I just care about the most popular
language I don't care about the second
place or the third place languages or
anything else well let me add one more
Clause here limit the answer to one and
no matter how many rows should come back
now I just get the number one language
as of the data set we collected with 27
uh 270 votes for
it
questions on
this any questions
here no well what if uh you know we're
starting to introduce SQL and it was
kind of too late to make it into the
this the Google form so it turns out
there Syntax for this too you can create
data of course not just the tables but
the data they're in and here's like the
typical Syntax for inserting data into a
SQL database you literally say insert
into the name of the table and then in
parentheses you specify one or more
columns for which you have values that
you want to insert this is to say you
don't have to give values for every
column in the given row if you only have
answers to some of those questions you
can enumerate them here like this but
the values you insert are going to be
these so you literally say after the
closed parenthesis values and then in a
second set of parentheses with the same
length comma separated list you specify
what values do you want to insert so
it's a little verbose and frankly longer
term you're going to use like python
code to automatically do these kinds of
insertions but let's go ahead and try
this right now if I do select
distinct uh language from favorites
again we see this just these three
candidates but we've now taught you a
bit of sequel so let's do insert into
favorites the column called
language uh and you know what let's I'm
going to give a problem here the values
for which and let me Zoom back out are
going to be quote unquote SQL and quote
unquote 50v you'll see soon see what
that's all about semicolon nothing seems
to happen but that's usually a good
thing and now if I scroll back up in my
my queries in SQL light three you can
scroll back and forth in time and uh to
avoid retyping things now I should see
indeed four candidate languages here now
suppose that you were never really a fan
of c and maybe you uh programmed a
little bit in high school or in the real
world and you liked C++ well there's a
whole lot of answers for C so select
star from favorites where language
equals quote unquote C so here's
everyone who submitted the answer for C
let's presume that no they didn't really
want C they wanted C++ which is not a
language we teach in the class but I
could also now do this you can use the
update command to set a column or
columns to different values where some
condition is met so if I do update table
name set column name equal to some value
filtering it perhaps by where some
condition is true so suppose I've
changed my mind or you know what let's
go ahead and do
update uh favorites set language equal
to maybe C++ where language equals c now
this is destructive so you generally
don't want to do this unless you have a
backup of your data too overriding what
people's answers are this seems to have
been successful because no error
messages and if I rerun the previous
select that gives me all of the
favorites where language equals c now
indeed I get none but if I search for
C++ now I get a lot and if I get rid of
that wear Clause altogether and just
look at the contents of my database now
you see that indeed C++ is comingled
with all the other data this is not what
you all intended of course so I can undo
this let me go ahead and undo what I
just did let me set my favorite language
to C where language equals C plus plus
but the predicate is important this I'm
not going to do what if I accidentally
omitted this predicate the wear Clause
how would that screw things up might you
think uh yeah I'm
back it would set Every Rose language to
indeed see and this is dangerous and if
you start googling around for like
sequel mistakes or the like people in
the real world have accidentally run
commands like this and without naming
names a former member of our teaching
staff at one point accidentally re ran a
command like this and changed every
student's name in our database to Bobby
I think it was the same name for every
row because they simply forgot a
predicate so here to two like there's
dangers in code and you should adopt The
Habit quite quickly of always one
backing up your data like with CP for
instance in Linux or any other technique
or just making sure before you hit enter
that yes this is indeed the query I want
to execute and generally speaking in the
real world there should be process
controls in place like the intern should
not have access to the datab the
production database the live database
and the like but you have a lot of power
now with these queries so just be all
the more careful cuz very easily can you
do bad things so let me undo this where
language equals quote unquote C++ and
I'll Zoom back out enter and now I think
we're back in business C is among the
answers
yeah is essentially doing what at the
end replace it's essentially find and
replace yes in like lay person's terms
this is find and replace implemented
with SQL and in fact the authors of
Microsoft Word or Google Docs might very
well be using language like this sequel
when you go to the nice graphical
userfriendly find and replace box this
may very well be what they're doing
underneath the hood or of course they
could be using some other language
altogether there's one last uh syntax
that's worth knowing delete which for
better for worse is even more
destructive whereby it allows you to
delete rows from tables it's distinct
from drop which lets you delete tables
themselves this focuses on rows so
suppose that you really really didn't
like let's say uh tedin was a little
challenging if you adopt if you tackle
that more comfortable problem so if you
really don't want to even think about t
in anymore so why don't we do uh delete
from favorites where problem equals and
I won't execute it for real tiamin this
would have the effect of deleting every
row including the language therein and
the time stamp where the student
answered tiamin worse than this would be
this why might this be bad
okay chuckling because like there's no
predicate there's no filter which means
literally this would delete all of the
data so again with great power here
comes great responsibility now this has
just been a data set of what 430 rows by
us dynamically created there's of course
some really juicy data sets in the real
world and one website you might have
heard or an app you might have used is
IMDb the internet movie database which
wonderfully makes some of their data
available for download as CSV files or
technically tsv files tab separated
values but what we did in advance of
class was download some of that data for
both TV shows in the real world and
movies in the real world and what's
wonderful about this data set is it's
not just dozens or hundreds or even
thousands of lines there are millions of
rows of Juicy data TV shows and movies
with which most folks are probably
familiar at least with the subset and
we'll see in just a little bit that this
data comes in the form of now six
different tables that we've given you
and the tables and question for today
are going to be the people in the TV
business the Stars they in the shows
that people are producing and the like
this is a picture we'll revisit to let
enable you to wrap your minds around
what the actual data is this feels like
a good opportunity though for a snack in
fact in just a moment we have a whole
lot of Rice Krispie treats out in the
lobby but if folks could perhaps
acknowledge uh this mini wedding cake
here cs50 own Carter zeni is getting
married this week so congratulations to
Carter
as
well
congrats all right there's
only okay there's only one piece of cake
in that box but a lot of Rice Krispy
Treats in the transip let's take 10
minutes and we'll be back with Internet
Movie Database in 10 all right we are
back so if you've never been like you
can actually go to I imdb.com right now
and play around or download the mobile
app and it's just big database of a lot
of TV show and movies and actors and the
like but what indeed is nice is you can
download some of that data and that's in
what I've done in advance and what we've
done is we wrote some python code to
convert some of the uh flat file
databases that they let you download and
we converted it into a SQL database with
six tables so not just one but six that
ultimately are these here and let me
just help you wrap your minds around
what this picture is which is a entity
relationship diagram which is just to
say each of these boxes on the screen
represents a table and each of the
arrows or edges represents some kind of
relationship across the tables because
up until now the only data we had were
those three columns in the favorites
table but what's gets really useful
about SQL databases just like a Google
spreadsheet or an Excel file is you can
have multiple sheets or in a database
multiple tables and so what we're about
to see is that in this IMDb database for
TV shows there's going to be a dedicated
table for all the people in the TV
business there's going to be a dedicated
table for all of the TV shows that are
in their database as of right now
there's going to be a dedicated table
for writers in that industry for the
ratings of uh shows for the genres to
which shows belong comedy and the like
and then lastly there's going to be this
table which somehow
Associates people with the TV shows that
they star in and vice versa and so let's
consider first what this looks like in
code and we'll see that it's going to
overwhelm intentionally at first but I'm
going to do this I'm going to go back to
my terminal window and during the break
I downloaded from the course's website a
file called shows. DB which we made in
advance for you and if I type LS I'll
see all of my favorites files from
before the CSV the DB and the python
file but now there's shows. DB so I'm
going to go ahead in my full screen
terminal window here I'm not using
actual tabs or code files now I'm going
to run SQL light3 on the file called
shows. DB and I'm just going to see this
version information here let me clear my
screen and run the one command I ran
earlier to show us the schema of the
favorites database now we'll see the
schema for the shows database and
there's a lot going on here but let me
scroll back up to the very top the
beginning and we see this here so when I
run. schema we see a dump really of all
of the SQL create table commands that
were run in order to create this
database for you and one of those tables
is called genres and another people
ratings shows stars and so forth and the
columns therein even though it's
formatted a little more prettily than
the automatically generated create table
statement for favorites whereby we have
one column per line of output here uh in
the for instance people table there's
going to be an ID column like unique
identifier like a Harvard ID a Yale ID
or the like uh a name column a birth
year and then some other stuff if I
scroll down to shows every show in the
world is going to have a unique ID as
well a title of course the year in which
it debuted and the total number of
episodes as of the time we downloaded
the data and then what else is there
some of these are a little less obvious
like ratings here so ratings don't have
an ID column but they have a show ID
column and a rating like a fivepoint
scale or 10o scale or the like and then
the total number of votes that were
collected to contribute to that rating
IMDb allows people to like up vote and
down vote uh shows and movies and the
like and then similarly is genre
structured there's a show ID and then
there's a genre which is going to be
like an English word like comedy or
drama or something else and then what
else let's go a little further at the
bottom here for stars and writers if we
go to the very bottom here stars and
writers are similarly structured too
they have a show ID and a person ID so
show and person and then this writer's
table has a show ID and a person ID and
there's a whole lot of other words that
we'll come to in just a moment but what
are the what is this code hinting at
well if I go back to the picture from
earlier here you'll see that this
picture captures the relationships among
these various tables so for instance if
we focus on shows for just a moment a
show again has a unique ID a title a
year in which it debuted and a total
number of episodes if you want to figure
out what genre or genr a show belongs to
cuz some shows are just comedies some
shows are just just dramas but you know
some shows are arguably comedies and
dramas depending on the episode or the
like so you can imagine wanting to
associate two or three or even more
genres with a show this line here in
this second table allows us to do that
every Row in the genres table we'll see
has uh two items a show ID which relates
to the ID of a show and that's why these
lines literally line up with that
specific column name and genre which is
going to be like quote unquote comedy
quote unquote drama or something else
now with that said design question why
have we deliberately not just gotten rid
of this genre's table and made our lives
simpler by just adding a genre column to
this shows table and again a table is
just like a sheet with rows and columns
at the moment shows only have four
columns ID title year episodes why not
just add a fifth column called genre and
put the show genre
there any intuition
here why not just keep things simple
like yeah and
back exactly if you add a fifth column
here and call it genre then you have to
pick a genre specifically you have to
put in that cell presumably comedy or
drama or music or something else now you
could write multiple words in the cell
but generally speaking that would be
sloppy bad design like every cell just
like in a spreadsheet should really have
one value it might have multiple words
but it shouldn't be like a weirdly comma
separated list of multiple things it
should just be in a different cell in
that case so if you instead were to
design this with just a single column
called genre you're imposing what a
computer scientist would call a on toone
relationship every show has one genre
and that's not necessarily a good thing
or strictly speaking it would be a many
to one because the same genre could
belong to multiple shows but each show
could only have one genre in that case
what a relational database allows you to
do and relational is indeed the
operative word it allows you to factor
out some of your information and then
have maybe one show here in one row but
then in this genres table you could have
one row for that one show genre or you
could have two rows in the genres table
for comedy and for drama or if it has a
third genre you could just add another
row here so you still have one row for
the show itself with all the juiciest
details but a variable number of rows by
having this relationship with another
table meanwhile ratings work the same
way at least in this case a show has ID
title year and episodes but if you want
to figure out its rating you have to
kind of Follow the arrow here so to
speak and look up the corresponding show
ID in this table find the rating of that
show and the total number of ratings so
that's been factored out Two For Better
or For Worse um now let's consider
people people have just three columns ID
name and birth but there's no mention of
the TV show in which people have starred
or the TV shows that a person has
written well why is that well if you
just had a fourth column here called
show well you would have to decide what
show is that person in and no one could
ever act again in another show because
there's no room to store the data but if
someone of course a popular actor can St
star in multiple shows well we could
have one ID for that person one name one
birth year obviously like there's only
one Steve Carell as an actor in the
world of people but Steve Carell in this
example could have his person ID
whatever his Harvard ID equivalent Yale
ID equivalent is appear in multiple rows
in this table so that it can be
associated with multiple shows and this
allows you to create what's called a one
to many relationship or technically it's
bidirectional it's a many to many
relationship why well one show can
certain certainly have multiple people
in it and multiple people writing for it
just in the real world but conversely
one uh person could certainly act in
multiple shows or write multiple shows
so this is what you get with relational
databases you put your sort of canonical
data for people in one place for for
shows in another place and then you use
these additional tables to relate one
thing to another so we won't dwell on
the pictures that's just if you sort of
uh can wrap your mind around the data
set better that way that's one way of
thinking about it but recall that the
code we just saw for the schema again
escalated quickly like there's a lot of
keywords I haven't mentioned yet but
some of these are perhaps familiar
they're capitalized differently here but
integer is on the list here null is on
the list albeit technically not null so
let's tease apart some of these key
words and consider what they're actually
doing for your database because now
we're in exploring features that do not
exist in the world of spreadsheets alone
so it turns out in a SQL database
specifically SQL light which is the
version of SQL we use in cs50 and which
is commonly used for things like mobile
applications nowadays it's like a
lightweight version of SQL it's when you
aren't trying to run Twitter and have
billions and billions of rows
necessarily you've got hundreds
thousands tens of thousands maybe even a
few million but not crazy uh numbers uh
crazy amounts of data in the world of
SQL light specifically there's these
five data types so just like in C we had
int and Char and the like in SQL we have
these uh BL which is kind of funny but
it just means binary large object so
it's like a binary data type zeros and
ones that aren't necessarily uh fitting
into the other categories integer which
of course is an integer as we know it
numeric which is kind of a catchall for
numbers that are formatted specially so
like a date uh would be like year year
year year-month month Dash day day um
and this is actually a wonderful thing
depending on the country you're from you
might think your date system in your
country is great or it's horrible the US
system is horrible because we have month
day and then year which is impossible to
sort it is the wrong way objectively to
store data and yet here we are using
this at scale other countries have
gotten this better numeric and SQL
itself standardizes that stuff so it
doesn't matter what country you're from
you're storing your data in this
particular way for instance times are
standardized and other types of numeric
data as well real is synonymous with
float so something with a decimal point
and some number of uh digits thereafter
and then text is just uh for strings and
the like with other even fancier
databases like MySQL postgress SQL
Oracle and other products you might have
heard of there's even more data types
where you have to make even finer grain
decisions but for SQL light it's indeed
pretty lightweight and you or we just
have to decide the data types for each
column in a table but there's these
additional constraints in the world of
SQL you can additionally say that cells
in this column may or may not be null so
if you want to protect yourself from
yourself so you don't screw up and
insert a null that is a blank value you
can explicitly design a table to have a
column that cannot be null and so in
fact someone came up during the break to
ask me about my having manually inserted
SQL quote unquote SQL into our favorites
database you might recall that I kind of
cheated I just inserted uh SQL quote
unquote and 50v the name of a new
problem quote unquote but what did I not
insert into the
database a Tim stamp and I could have I
could have put like the current day in
time a few minutes ago but I didn't and
that's fine if it's uh if it's
acceptable to you and the product you're
building but I could have prevented that
if we had defined the table to have a
timestamp column that isn't just text
but it's text that's not null SQL would
have complained and would not have let
me complete that insertion so there's
these kinds of built-in defenses that
you don't necessarily get with a
spreadsheet alone and unique means
exactly that if you want to make sure
that every Row in that column is unique
maybe for email addresses or in the US
Social Security numbers or anything that
you want to make sure you don't have two
versions of you can specify that the
column is unique and there's other such
constraints as well but again this is
just a list of features that you get
from a proper relational database but
perhaps the most intellectually
interesting one and the most powerful
one is what's called here a primary key
and a foreign key and let me go back now
to this output if we look at shows
you'll see that a show again has an ID a
title a year and a number of episodes
and now the data types might make sense
the ID it turns out just like a Harvard
ID a Yale ID is going to be an integer
so a simple number the title of course
is going to be text but not null like it
would be weird if a TV show had no name
like that can't be like every the whole
world would break or your TV gu and
whatnot so that makes sense there to say
not null uh year is numeric so it's a
standardized form episodes is an integer
like how many episodes have been
produced and then lastly notice this the
primary key of the show's table is
apparently the column called ID
mentioned a few lines earlier this just
means that the database will use the ID
column as the unique identifier so it's
similar to the unique keyword but
primary key just means the database is
going to treat it as special too and
make sure that it is uniquely
identifying your data but what's
interesting is this notice if I scroll
back up to people people were sort of
similarly structured but with different
attributes like up here we had a person
has an ID a name a birth year and a
primary key of ID so a ID is again
integer name is text but not null
because it'd be weird to have a human
with absolutely no name textually birth
is going to be numeric but the primary
key of people is ID as well so those are
the unique columns that the database
will just treat special why well we just
looked at shows we just looked at people
let's focus now on this one down here
Stars how do you determine who star in a
TV show well we had two columns the show
ID and the person ID this is the ex the
Incarnation of a many to- many
relationship one person could be in many
shows one show could certainly have many
people in it or writing for it but
notice this within this table of two
columns show ID and person ID there's
what's going to be called a foreign key
called show ID that references the shows
tables ID column and then another
foreign key called person ID though I
could call these things in parentheses
anything I want that references the
people tables ID column now you're not
going to often have to type commands
like this again you set the database up
once in the beginning typically maybe
with some help from a TF maybe with help
of Google or the like but once your
database is designed it's back to the
crud like create read update delete the
selects the inserts the deletions and
the like but what's this implying these
keywords like primary key and foreign
key are what are doing in code what this
picture was painting a moment ago these
lines here are drawn literally to line
up with the corresponding things
people's ID lines up with person ID
Show's ID lines up with show ID and so
you're just seeing graphical version
code version graphical code that creates
these relationships now given that let's
actually see what these things look like
so let me go back to vs code here let me
clear my screen I'm still within SQL
light with shows. DB let me go ahead and
do what I do with like any new database
if I ever download something or I'm
trying to wrap my mind around a problem
you know usually it doesn't come with a
pretty picture or uh you know a
three-hour lecture to explain what the
data set is rather you just have the
data set in your own knowledge of SQL so
let me play around so schema shows me
all the tables that might be a starting
point okay this is interesting I know PE
what people are let's go ahead and show
me all the people so select star from
people I'm just trying to wrap my mind
around what this data set looks like in
a more userfriendly way okay okay that's
already a lot of people as you see the
years flying by there's been a lot of
people in the TV
business so this was maybe not the best
query to run but this is indicative of
just how large this data set is from
IMDb okay when in doubt and when
whenever you lose control over your
computer control C is your friend to
interrupt what would have been better
because I don't think I need to know all
the million people in the world I could
do like limit me to 10 people all right
and that's enough now to get us sense of
like Fred a stair has an IDE of one
first person ever um birth year of 1899
Lauren ball and all of these other uh
people from yesterday year you see that
they are the first 10 people in the
database so there's an example of some
of the data now if I want to rep my mind
around what a show is you know I know it
technically I know it from the picture
but let's just look at some raw data so
instead of saying select star from
people let me go ahead and select star
from shows limit 10 and okay I've only
heard heard of or seen a couple of these
but these are older shows at that but I
see that every show has an ID a title a
year in which it debuted and a number of
episodes but perhaps most opaque is
going to be this select star from
Stars where this is the table that
Associates people with shows am I going
to see any names or show titles here not
according to the definition we saw
earlier oh I should have done my limit
let me interrupt that let me do that
again limit 10
no and this is where now you're
definitely in the programmer world
because like this would be the most
annoying spreadsheet to use on your Mac
or PC ever if you just had like a sheet
with all of these numbers that
Associates one thing with the other like
my God how do you figure out who this is
or what this is you have to like
manually control F or command F looking
for the data but a database doesn't care
once you know SQL you can sort of Stitch
these things back together so what
you're seeing here are foreign Keys
foreign Keys why because show ID
corresponds to the same numbers from
that other table called shows that has
an proper primary key called ID person
ID is a foreign key in this context
because it refers to numbers that belong
to really the people table and its ID
column so this is just a way of somehow
linking them and so if you think of I
always like think of um this in my
mind's eye is this if this is like the
people table this is the shows table and
there's this middle table in between the
Stars table there's some way of like
stitching those two together by lining
up the idas of one with the other and
getting back some more data so let's
actually play with some of this data how
about we start where we emphasized
earlier genres so let me go ahead and
take a quick look at all of the genres
in this database so select star from
genres star is usually going to be a
little overwhelming but it just gives me
a sense of what the data is but let's
actually look at um uh let's go look at
all of them there okay that's a lot
these are all official genres from IMDb
let me oh okay it went okay it wasn't
terribly long let me filter that down so
from genres where genre equals comedy uh
Capital C just based on the data I'm
seeing okay so what am I seeing now and
in fact let me limit this arbitrarily to
10 though I could limit it to anything I
want here are 10 comedies what are they
well who the heck knows like all I know
are the 10 show IDs now I could do
something like this as we've seen before
with SQL I could do all right well let's
figure out what this show idea is Select
star from shows where the IDE of the
show I'm looking for equals what 62 614
semicolon so I could like manually look
it up by cross referencing the other
table okay so that was the show in
question there the first comedy in the
data set let me look up the second one
so instead of that let's do 6 3881 enter
okay so that's that show and let's do
one more and suffice it to say this is
just getting tedious and vulnerable to
mistakes quickly this is not this surely
can't be the way to do this and indeed
SQL is going to let us do this a little
more powerfully instead let's do this
instead of getting this table
temporarily with all these show IDs and
all these genres let's refine the query
so let's just select the show ID from
the genres table where the genre equals
quote unquote comedy now I have a big b
list of show IDs all of which are comedy
how many well I can combine ideas from
earlier I can just count all of those
show IDs and or Star if I want to just
do that too but I can count all those
show IDs
4876 comedies and IMDB's database for TV
shows so feels like a lot but how can I
now use that information and get back
the titles of comedies in the database
without doing it manually well let's do
this I have a moment ago this query
select the show ID from genres where the
current genre is quote unquote
comedy um what if I kind of Nest these
queries kind of like grade school math
in parenthesis what if I combine this
whole thing in parenthesis and now let
me select what I really want let me go
ahead and select how about uh the title
of all shows where the idea of the show
is in this list of show
IDs so if you agree that the shows table
has an ID column which is its otherwise
known as its primary key the unique ID
that identifies it just like our Harvard
IDs our Yale IDs and you agree that per
a moment ago this shorter query will
give me back just the show IDs of all of
the comedies in the database you can
actually combine or Nest these queries
together uh it's going to respect SQL
light order of operations with
parentheses just like grade school math
so the thing in parentheses will be
executed first that gives it back a list
of IDs like what 48,000 IDs and then
this query the outer query is going to
get the title from all of the shows
where the ID of the show is in that big
list of 48,000 so if I now execute these
together I think the list is still going
to be a little long but let me execute
it together now I see this long list of
outputs a little overwhelming let's go
ahead and maybe limit it to just 10 as
before for discussion sake and now I see
10 comedies ordered arbitrarily from
however they're in the database that
happen to indeed be have comedy as their
genre if I want to do this a little more
cleanly I could do this let's see uh why
don't I order by title ascending order
which is alphabetically or the default
is also uh ascending limit 10 now I see
the top 10 I mean weirdly named things
with hash symbols presumably to get
their titles up to the beginning or
maybe these are hashtags uh here now we
have alphabetically the top first 10
shows that are
comedies any questions on these kinds of
queries it's kind of a lot but at the
same time it's just like composing the
smaller ideas from before into slightly
more useful
queries
yeah do for Keys have to set the
relationship when you create the table
the programmer or the database
administrator would create that
relationship by using those keywords
primary key and foreign key that create
that teaches the database what is
related to what per the picture so you
do that once and now I being the sort of
programmer who's familiar with the
database I am just using these foreign
keys in a way in a manner consistent
with their design but and this is where
it's useful at some point even if you no
one hands you a picture to make sure you
understand the database because that's
going to inform literally what you type
in SQL to get the data you care about
about well let's do something a little
more precise how about very reasonable
question and honestly this is exactly
what imdb.com in the app are for what if
you want to find all of the shows that
Steve Carell is in like kind of a
reasonable query like literally
something someone might type into Google
or more specifically IMDb it's not
really obvious at first glance how to do
that though because right like from my
database if these are my six tables well
I can pretty easily get Steve Carell
from here but I can really only get his
ID number whatever that is his name
which I know already and his birth year
okay interesting but has nothing to do
with the shows that he's in I can look
at shows over here but there's no
mention of Steve Carell right because
there's no person ID here where is that
relationship implemented well it's
implemented down here so how do we do
this well here's the perfect example of
a a lesson we've trying been trying to
emphasize for weeks of taking these baby
steps like break larger problems down
into smaller ones and let's do something
like this let's just get everything I
know about Steve Carell from the
database let's select star from people
where the name of the person is quote
unquote Steve Carell I just want to see
what data we've got and here's what we
have okay there's only one Steve Carell
born in 1962 and his unique ID is 136
797 according to IMDb this isn't some
like Global uh actor identifier per se
all right well how do I get now all of
the shows that Steve Carell is in well I
could do this
select star from Stars not to confuse
the two one's the symbol one's the table
name uh where person ID equals 13
6797 so I think this will now give me
everything from the Stars table that
relates to Steve Carell okay and you'll
see person ID is the same because I'm
literally searching for just Steve
Carell but there are what like 20 or so
shows that he's been in all right well
here's where things would get tedious
what are those shows well I could do
Select Title from shows where the ID of
the show equals and here's you know
whenever you copy paste you're probably
doing something wrong okay he's was in
The Dana Carvey Show familiar with that
let's do another one we'll copy paste
this uh where ID equals this over the
top another and if we keep digging we'll
probably find the office but my God like
that's going to take forever to do 20
queries manually it's not very Dynamic
but what if we just Nest these queries a
little more dynamically so let me start
from the beginning again what if we go
ahead and select everything we want we
know about uh people whose name
equals
Steve Carell that gave us earlier this
data I don't need all of that data I
know his name I don't care about his
birth year so let's change this to just
be give me the ID of Steve Carell and
that gives me back now this smaller
temporary data set all right can I now
use
this uh inside of another query well let
me wrap the whole thing with parentheses
and now let me say select star from the
Stars table where the person ID equals
this so I'm Del liely not using in
because I'm assuming there's indeed only
one Steve Carell in the world so I'm not
getting back a list of Steve Carell I'm
getting back the one and only in this
case so equal is fine in is when you
have multiple equal is when you have one
let me go ahead and hit enter now okay
that's more data than I need I don't
need like 20 copies of Steve Carell's
person ID so let me hit up let me go
back and let me just get show ID from
Steve Carell and now I have a list of
just the 20 or so show IDs that he has
been in all right how can I now use this
well let me hit up let me put the whole
thing in parentheses and now let me
select what I really want Select Title
from shows where and here's the final
flourish the shows table has an ID has a
title has a year and has an episode and
what I really want though is to check
which
shows have ID that is what anyone want
to finish the thought
I just want to
yeah exactly ID in this and this is
getting ugly and when you actually write
your queries in like a text file you can
format them nicely and indent them my
font is just getting I don't want to
make it too small to fit everything but
now we have three queries one is in
doubly nested parenthesis then there's
the middle one then there's the outer
one so this last query is going to get
me the title from shows where the ID of
the show is in this big list of 20 or so
show IDs that Steve Carell is in and I
knew that because I looked up his name
here and notice what I did not do this
time is I didn't manually hardcode his
ID number there's no need that would be
kind of a bad way to implement a website
uh if you're using a database underneath
the hood you want the IMDb for real to
search for whatever the human typed in
and no one's going to know Steve
Carell's person ID or anything else so
here we've done this all dynamically and
now if I hit enter I think I get all of
his shows let's go ahead and order this
by title just to make it tidy and you
probably will see at least one or more
shows that you know and probably the
most popular is dot dot dot the office
so this is literally the kind of query
that's being executed underneath the
hood when you go to uh websites or apps
like IMDb your textual query is probably
being plugged into a longer SQL query
like this where some programmer at IMDb
probably wrote this whole query in
advance weeks months years ago and
they're just somehow plugging in the
value that you the human type into the
search box or the like questions
now on finding this data or any
other no okay so where else could we go
with this well let's
consider how else we might combine data
suppose that the next question actually
perhaps appropriately would be focusing
in on not just like people and shows and
these stars but how do we kind of like
gather more information about the shows
themselves like the genres the ratings
or the like so indeed let's focus on
just these two tables here recall that
every show has an ID a title a year and
episodes but it also might have one or
more relationships with rose and this
other table is called genres and this is
so that a show can be a comedy can be a
drama can be any number of other things
one row per so you would see the same
show ID again and again and again with a
different genre written in English like
comma comedy drama or the like well how
do I kind of Recon subtitute that data
Well turns out there's a few different
ways to do this and let me propose that
we introduce this keyword here join and
this is really the most powerful of the
keywords in SQL itself it doesn't have
to be used we've seen with uh nested
queries that you can still select data
across multiple tables but here is
another way so let me do this let me go
back to my SQL light database and let me
select sort of in one uh breath exactly
the data I want select star from shows
and let's just limit this initially to
10 to see what it looks like all right
that's again the shows data select star
from genres let's limit that to 102 just
to wrap our minds around it and now this
is not that useful however the data in
the leftmost column here is the primary
key in the shows table these are just
unique IDs the data here in the genres
table recall show ID is the foreign key
so it's the same numbers but just copied
into another table so that we can have
this relationship across them how do I
kind of line up these numbers with these
numbers to get back like a wider table
that has title and year and episodes and
genre and heck ratings and all of that
too if we want well you can join these
Tables by just telling the database what
to join on what so let me do this select
star from shows join that table though
on the genres table well how do you want
to join those two tables and again the
two tables from the picture looked like
this how do you tell SQL
programmatically to sort of you know put
one of them right next to the other line
up all of the ID so that you just get
one larger data set well we can use
indeed this this query this uh syntax
called join so back to VSS code here and
let me join these two
tables sorry typo here join genres on
the shows tables ID column AKA it's
primary key equaling the genres tables
show ID column aka the foreign key so in
other words it looks a little cryptic
but I'm just telling SQL how to line up
these two tables and what column to
match with the other so that the numbers
line up and I get essentially a wider
table let me go ahead and hit uh
semicolon and enter and this is now
going to give me a lot of data we might
have to interrupt it but notice even at
a glance we're getting the ID the title
the year the number of episodes the ID
again redundantly but that's to be
expected if I'm joining them and the
genre all the way on the right let me
hit contrl C to interrupt let me just
limit this to the office so where title
equals quote unquote the office so we
can focus on just one sample uh datum
and here fun fact there's been more than
one office the one that you all probably
like is this one that started in 2005
with 188 episodes its ID in the shows
table is 3866 76 that's confirmed over
here too so again we've just joined the
two tables how by lining up those fields
but now that we can see that almost all
of the offices produced over the decades
are comedies except for this one there
was a version of the office produced in
2001 that was considered more of uh a
drama no unsure if it's related to the
other how can we Link in other data well
let's go ahead and Link in ratings too
or instead so instead of joining this
with genres let me go ahead and Rewind
here and join shows on ratings on shows.
ID equals ratings. show ID and let's
limit it to the office 2 for discussion
sake where uh title equals quote unquote
the office semicolon and now you can see
that among the various offices it looks
like the one that most of us probably
know and love is the highest rated also
with a 9.0 with like 585,000 people
having cast votes for whereas these
other shows seem to have been less
popular perhaps that's why indeed you
see fewer episodes for them as well so
even though we've put the data in
multiple places you can still kind of
reconstitute it by lining things up in
this way and rejoining the tables
questions now on
this like this is the heart of what SQL
does and what relational databases do
for
you
questions all right a few final features
like there's not all that much that uh
you know SQL takes practice like
anything else but in terms of syntax and
capabilities let's just introduce you to
a couple of final features here and how
and problems that arise and how we might
solve them let's do this uh as well so
let me go back into VSS code here and
let's just find out um Steve Carell's
information again last time we did it
with this nested nested query by getting
his ID and then the show IDs and then
the titles for those show IDs with join
you can do it a little differently and
any of these ways are fine one might
become EAS easier to you mentally than
another let's go ahead and select the
titles from what let's select the title
from uh the people table but and I'm
going to hit enter and when you're using
SQL light 3 interactively if you ever
find yourself with a prompt that says
dot dot dot angle bracket it means
you're continuing your thought onto the
next line if you didn't intend that you
can sometimes hit uh semicolon to just
end the thought and hit enter and just
even if it triggers an error but this is
one way of formatting my queries now a
little more nicely I'm just going to add
some wh space so that it's a little
easier to read what do I want to select
well I want to select the title of shows
from the people table joined with the
Stars table on the people tables ID
column equaling the Stars tables person
ID column so in other words if you think
back to what people are and what stars
are one has an ID one has a person ID
I'm just now connecting those two tables
I'm joining those two but I want to do
this as well with with another table let
me additionally join in so now I only
have two hands but now I'm putting a
third table joined in together here join
shows on stars. show ID equals shows. ID
so this is now linking three tables
together but I only care about this for
one person so where the name of the
person equals quote unquote Steve Carell
so more cryptic to be to be sure but
what we're doing with this query is just
taking all three tables that we care
about and we're joining them them all
together at once using this new join
syntax literally telling the database
what columns to line up with what and
then we filter at the very end just like
before to get back if I hit enter the
answer we want which in this case is a
little slower at the moment but that
same list of uh 20 or so shows that he's
been in there's one other way to do this
and again uh these are all in the slides
online so you can repeat them without
having to jot down everything and we'll
put them in the notes too but there's
another way to do this I could also use
an implicit join so that was an explicit
join because I literally typed the word
join multiple times at that but let me
go ahead and select the title from these
three tables people stars and shows and
this might just be nicer because if you
know what tables you want to select data
from just enumerate them separated by
commas which you might prefer in your
mind where the people ID equals the
Stars person
ID and the Stars show ID equals the
shows ID and the name of the person
equals Steve Carell so this is an
implicit joint and honestly I constantly
reference my notes for some of this
stuff too it's not the kind of thing
that's going to come like this to you
after just one day but it's just a
different way of expressing the same
thing I want to select data from three
different tables and hey SQL here is how
I want you to line those tables up so
that I can get like related data for
Steve Carell and this now will achieve
the same results ultimately let me hit
enter
H and there we go so a little slower and
performance might vary based on computer
based on uh implementation of SQL but I
think I still have the same answers now
suppose as I'm often do and I had to
look it up again last time suppose you
forget what uh how to spell Steve
Carell's name is it two RS two L's or
the like well I could also do something
like this select well let's just keep
this simple select star from people
where name equals I've been deliberately
getting it right so as to not embarrass
myself that's the Steve Carell I keep
querying if you forget well you could
try searching for just Steves but there
interestingly there's a bunch of Steves
we don't know when they were born uh but
that's probably not the Steve Carell we
want if we don't have his last name so I
could alternatively do well it's Steve
and then it's starts with a C I think
well it turns out there's another wild
card you can use in SQL we used the
asterisk to select all of the columns
you can in quotes use a percent sign to
say see something so there's some zero
or more characters after the letter c
and now this doesn't work cuz now I
would be literally looking for Steve
space c something but recall earlier I
mentioned that one other keyword which
is for fuzzier matching so to speak
where it's like not exactly what you're
looking for but it's like what you're
looking for if you instead say where his
name is like Steve space c something now
we'll get back a whole bunch of Steves
but I think now I could probably find
the one I'm actually looking for if I
don't remember his name you can use
multiple percent signs if you forget
what his first name is you could reverse
the order but that too is a uh very
powerful sequel feature at that
questions on these queries here
yeah
sorry what about
it oh yeah sure so the query I used here
there's a lot of Steves whose last name
starts with C oops too far uh the last
query I executed was this one here so
where the name is like quote unquote
Steve C percent sign so that's just
another tool for your toolkit here but
you'll you'll perhaps have noticed that
those two the prior to that query the
joins I did were sort of slow and
honestly this database isn't even that
big like yes it has tens of thousands of
rows in it but like in the real world
and most of the apps you and I use a lot
every day or websites like there's
Millions even billions of rows of data
and like if I had to wait on like my
computer here or my code space like a
second or two to get the data like
that's not going to work for millions of
users or customers certainly so how can
we actually improve things well it turns
out another upside of a proper
relational database is that it's not
just a spreadsheet where the onus is on
like you to like find the data you're
looking for you can also tell the
database to index the data for you an
index is an an efficient uh cheat sheet
for Finding data fast like books in the
real world often have indices at the end
of the at the end of the book where you
can look things up alphabetically and
then you can cross reference it for the
pages that that topic appears on same
idea in a database if you tell the
database in advance that you want to
search on a certain column frequently
you can tell it to build a fancy index
that will just allow you to search that
column Faster by default these columns
are going to be searched most likely via
linear search like not even binary
search because the data might not be
sorted because it came in in any order
but if you create an index you're
probably going to get something closer
to logar rmic than linear and that's
going to be a big plus overall so let me
do something simple here first let me
turn on a SQL light specific feature
that just is going to time all of my
queries by writing do timer on I just
want to keep track of uh how long each
of these commands takes this one is not
a slow command so this is just going to
be relative but let's just select
everything from the shows table where
the title thereof is the office let's
see how long this relatively simple
query takes all right not very long at
all in real terms like less than a
second .035 seconds so not slow by any
means but if you've got hundreds
thousands millions of users like every
one of those milliseconds could very
well add up so can we do better well we
can if I do this if I use syntax like
this once in the beginning of the design
of my database I create not a table but
an index with some name on a specific
table on one or more columns I can give
a clue a hint to the database in advance
saying please optimize with some Secret
Sauce searching or selecting on this
column in this table so that my searches
are faster so let me do this let me go
back to vs code here let me create an
index called how about title index I
could call it anything I want but I want
to search faster on titles so I'm going
to call this a title index where uh
rather uh title index on the table
called shows and then in parentheses is
the syntax the column called title so
again I've just borrowed this canonical
syntax and I've just translated into
something that's TV show specific all
right what is this going to do for me
once I hit enter this is going to create
in the computer's memory the database's
memory something called a b tree it's
not a binary tree a b tree is actually a
potentially more efficient data
structure that we didn't talk about a
few weeks back in week five but it looks
a little something like this which looks
similar to a binary tree but does anyone
notice what makes this not a binary tree
exactly binary tree by implying two has
no more than two children per node but
here's a perfect example one two three
and there could be four children five
children or more but the effect of that
if you have a very wide tree the upside
is that it's like very short like it
pulls the data higher up closer to the
node to the root node and recall that
the root node is where we began our
searches in the past whether it was a
BST a binary search tree even a try or
data structures we always began at the
top so the higher up you can pull the
data even if it makes the data structure
very wide you're going to be able to do
boom boom boom look up queries look up
data probably much faster certainly than
if it's just a very long list like a
column by default so with that said let
me go back to vs code I didn't create
the index yet let me go ahead and hit
enter and create it all right it took a
minute a moment it took like half a
second which obviously is not that slow
but with more data that could have been
even slower but it's a onetime operation
as of now and now let me hit up and let
me select the same data from shows where
title equals the office last time just a
moment ago it took 0.035 seconds no not
slow but also that's going to add up if
I have lots of users of IMDb let's go
ahead now and execute the same query
again how long did that
take
0.01 seconds now I mean practically
nothing and so that's the sort of
opportunity now when you've got lots of
data and you want to really speed up
these searches these indexes these
indices that just create for you these
magical data structures in the databases
memory it allows you to search on
columns that you are pretty sure you
want to search on more effectively Now
by contrast if you've ever used like
Google or Bing or some search engine
that has advanced search some of those
text boxes that you can search more
precisely in might very well be slower
why well probably you don't want to go
crazy and just index every column on
every table why well what might be the
intuition like if logically indexes
speed things up why not index everything
there's always going to be a tradeoff
here what might that
be
yeah yeah it's going to take a lot of
storage right this is just a slide on
the screen but like this has to go
somewhere like this needs space in the
computer's memory or on the hard drive
or the like and that's fine if you have
unlimited space but odds are like you
don't and that's going to get expensive
for different reasons so maybe you only
want to index certain columns and
certain tables and not all of them
because you know what even if a user
really wants to search maybe VI advanced
search on some other column or table
altogether fine if once in a while a
query is slow like we're probably
getting the bigger bang for our buck by
optimizing the common cases the more
popular queries that people actually
care about
too all right so let's come full circle
and bring this now back to uh how how we
actually began which was with some uh
python code so it turns out these are
not either or decisions it turns out in
the real world developers are constantly
using one two three languages at once in
fact next week I rattled off HTML CSS
and JavaScript one of which is a proper
programming language but those languages
are often used together totally normal
and common to use Python and SQL or Java
in SQL or Swift in SQL or any number of
different combinations with a database
language you might use use your
preferred programming language Java
python C++ to create the user interface
and the logic that builds the uh the
that implements the program itself but
for your data like SQL is a really good
candidates and indeed we've seen already
that SQL can just speed up certain
operations you can change you can uh
collapse 15 lines of code into just one
and you can use these things together so
let me come back to I'm going to quit
out of SQL light I'm going to minimize
my terminal window and here's where we
left off before with favorite .p with
favorites. everything was being stored
in uh favorites. CSV and recall that we
eventually imported that CSV file into
favorites. DB automatically with import
just so we could start playing around
with SQL but we can now tie these two
together and a way to do that is as
follows um cs50 has a library for python
you might recall having available uh get
string get int get float you don't
strictly need to use them in Python
because it's much easier to just use the
input function and then try accept and
convert things to int or float or the
like but it's a lot more work to use SQL
in Python without a third-party Library
a lot of the commercial options or
popular open source options are actually
just complicated to use so cs50 does
have a very useful function inside of
its library for python that you should
use and must use for the problem set
that just makes it easy to execute
python uh execute SQL inside of your
python code but it's built on top of a
very popular open source alternative so
you can use that too in the real world
so the documentation for that at this
URL here but I'll show you what we need
to know here by focusing back on
favorites.i so what I'm going to do here
as follows is this let me delete
everything from favorites. py except for
let's say uh this from cs50 import SQL
in all caps so that's importing a SQL
feature from cs50's library that's going
to allow me to open a DB file in code
how do I do that well let me create a
variable called DB for database though I
could call it anything I want let me
call this SQL function and pass in using
special syntax that's not cs50 specific
it's an industry thing SQL light colon
slash slash slash unlike every other URL
you type this one literally has three in
this context here and then the name of
the database which in this case is
favorites. DB so this is just a way of
telling this SQL library that we wrote
but that works exactly like third party
Alternatives openen favorites. DB using
the SQL light technology if you will all
right let's just ask the user a question
give me your favorite um uh problem so
we're going to use input instead of get
string but we could use get string but
they're pretty much the same for our
purposes let's ask the user for their
favorite and now in Python code let us
select from favorites. DB all of the
rows where students specify that problem
as their favorite so in SQL alone it
would be this select uh star from
favorites where problem equals and I'll
do um well whatever my favorite's going
to be like problem equals Mario for
instance so if I were just using SQL I
would literally write something like
that but I'm in a piy file now like I
have to use Python syntax but python
supports strings SQL is just text it's
just a string so I could certainly just
put my SQL code in a string perhaps and
then pass it to a python function and
here's the bridge between the two if you
just treat SQL as any old text we can
put it in a string and execute it so let
me actually do this let me go ahead and
create a variable called rows which is
eventually going to contain all the rows
from the database let me go ahead and uh
select db. execute this is the one
function you need to know about inside
of cs50's library and it literally
executes a SQL statement and then in
quotes you pass it literally what you
want to execute and let me go ahead and
close the parenthesis at the end there
and now let me just try this so for Row
in rows let's iterate over all of the
rows let me go ahead and print out how
about uh row quote unquote and what do I
want here uh let's print out the Tim
stamp of that person for kicks all right
let me open open my terminal window
python of favorites. Pi crossing my
fingers here for
sure
enter uh uh there we go favorit so I'll
type in
Mario okay so I got back it's not very
interesting but I got back all of the
timestamps of students who typed in
Mario that we imported into this
database well what I really care about
is how popular Mario is so let me change
this a little bit let me change this to
count the number of rows and let me keep
it simple let me give an alias like I
proposed earlier like as n where N is a
number so that now down here I can
actually just do this print out the
value of n all right let me go back to
my terminal window run python to
favorites. py let me type in Mario enter
okay 39 now technically I'm cheating
like honestly if I'm executing select
count we've seen before it only ever
returns one row not multiple so there's
really nothing to iterate over but it's
working fine it's just just iterating
once but I'm getting lucky so
technically what I should probably just
do is this I should probably give myself
like a variable called row set it equal
to the very first row and only row that
came back and now print out that rows n
column let me rerun the program I'll
type in Mario again enter and I still
see
39 so this of course I don't strictly
need to do this I don't really need a
variable I can do Row Bracket Z instead
but let me focus on what this library is
now doing so per the documentation what
the C what the cs-50 execute function
always does for you is it returns a list
of dictionaries so if your query returns
nothing like no matches you get back an
empty list like Open Bracket close
bracket nothing in it any Loop is not
going to execute anything useful because
there's nothing in it if though you get
back one row you're going to get back a
list of size one in inside of which is a
single dictionary that dictionary is
going to have keys that correspond to
whatever you selected be it the columns
or the count so when I selected star
before I could have like I would have
gotten all of the columns that's how I
was able to access timestamp here I'm
just selecting count and I don't want to
have to type this down here that would
just look kind of atrocious it would
work but it would look weird to just
keep retyping count peren star close pen
so I just created an alias called n just
to like make this my life easier or
cleaner down here so to be clear the SQL
the cs50 execute function returns a list
of dictionaries when you're using select
and that is how I can now get back the
first and only row and then print out
that Row's n value it is identical to
let me do this let me highlight this
whole line of text let me in my terminal
window run SQL light three of favorites.
DB like we did before break let me just
copy paste this query enter that that's
the table I got back earlier when we
played with SQL manually and so when I
get back this table here's the key
here's the value and I only have one row
which is why I'm just blindly indexing
into rows bracket zero because I know
there's always going to be an answer
there it's going to be zero or one or
more but I know now it's going to be
called n because of this here so what
have I just done well this is SQL down
here and this is just me being like a
data scientist asking questions about my
data just using like black and white SQL
queries this is me now being a python
programmer who wants to talk to a SQL
database using Python and The Bridge
we're using happens to be the cs-50
library but again there's third party
free libraries you can also use as well
ours is just very simple and indeed the
documentation will explain how execute
behaves a little differently for inserts
updates and deletes you don't get back a
list because you're not selecting
anything but you do get back some return
values questions on
this that's the last of our python code
that ties everything together in
spirit
yeah uh what this this one
here yes so db. execute by definition
returns a list of rows and each of those
rows happens to be a dictionary because
it's convenient key value pairs if I'm
selecting the count of rows I just know
from Having learned squel an hour ago
that this is always going to give me a
single row whose column in this case is
called n so if I know it's a single row
I can just blindly just like in C go
into that list or an array in C and go
to the first location and then treat
that as the single row what you don't
want to do is this even if you the human
know the query returns one row you can't
just magically change the variable name
to be singular and expect to have only
one value you will always have a list so
even if there is only one value in it
it's up to you to do something like this
to get at it or if you prefer more
succinctness you can do rose bracket I
bracket n that'll achieve the same thing
without a variable
yeah good so I have been misleading this
whole time and cheating because this is
only ever going to return Mario I'm
ignoring the favorite that the human
typed in here on line five so let me fix
that and that's going to lead us to some
of the problems that arise ultimately
with SQL the right way to solve that
problem let me get rid of my terminal
window here the right way to solve this
problem is not to use an F string like
we did in Python generally because SQL
queries as we'll see in a moment can be
dangerous when you want to plug in users
uh data into a query that you've written
most of in advance you should you must
you had better use a placeholder namely
a question mark in this case this is
somewhat specific to cs50's library but
we just borrowed the convention that
like every other Library uses too in the
world of SQL single question marks are
used as placeholders and the way you do
this is as follows if you want to plug
in a value for that question mark just
like in print F in C you specify as a
second or a third or fourth argument all
of the values you want plugged into this
so in C weeks ago we were using percent
s same exact idea in SQL it's a question
mark that you use instead this now if I
open back my terminal window and I run
uh python of favorites. type in Mario I
should still get 39 but now I can also
type in scratch perhaps and get 44 for
that very first piece at zero and that
one is even more popular here so this
now is correct it would work to use an F
string here and then plug in a value
like favorite here but you'll see in
just a moment don't do that you will
expose yourself to potential hack or
attacks um by trusting the user's input
and so in fact let's transition from
that to exact some of these kinds of
challenges namely two before we wrap up
so in the world of SQL especially when
it's used at scale at the Twitter and
the Googles of the world like a lot of
lots of data is probably coming into the
database all at once because multiple
people are opening their phones at the
same time around the world they're
clicking on the same links roughly at
the same time around the world when you
have thousands of people all using your
site at once like order of operations is
going to be important but unfortunately
in SQL and in other contexts of
computing there's this risk of what's
known as a race condition so for
instance has anyone ever seen or liked
this this is like yes the world record
egg or it's like this thing that was
very popular while back it's still kind
of going strong but if you go to the
Instagram profile for world record egg
uh the goal was to make the most most
liked Instagram post ever and they did
pretty well it's just this it's just a
picture of an egg now at the height of
the popularity like there might have
been hundreds thousands tens of
thousands of people clicking pretty much
at the same time on this egg so it
actually creates a potential problem
with the Integrity of Instagram's data
why well if you're have all these
requests coming in at once how do you
possibly keep track of all of them and
update your counter in a way that can
keep up with all of that traffic why
well let's just hypothesize what meta
formerly Facebook was doing underneath
the hood with Instagram if this were
their code so suppose for the sake of
discussion that Instagram servers are
using a mix of python and SQL probably
not using the cs50 library but they
could absolutely be using those two
languages or two others together um
suppose they do this in order to update
the number of likes for that post they
first execute a SQL query like select
the current number of likes from a table
called posts where the ID of the post
equals whatever the unique identifier is
for that spec specific egg in the table
and then they store the result in this
row variable just like I did and then
they do this they grab uh they create a
variable called likes they set it equal
to rows bracket Z so the very first row
in the result set and they get the likes
key so this is literally what I just did
with the count let me hypothesize that
Instagram does something similar with
the total number of likes why are they
doing this because they then want to
execute a third line of code that
executes update the posts table set the
new number of likes equal to something
where the ID of the post equals this
other thing now notice just like in
printf there's the comma separated list
of values they want to update the
current number of likes from the current
value to the current value plus one so
it's likes plus one and then we plug in
the ID for this so suppose this is what
Instagram's doing unfortunately whenever
you execute multiple lines of code
independently and you're so popular like
Instagram that you have thousands
hundreds of thousands of servers
potentially it is quite possible that if
you and I and everyone else in the room
clicks that egg at the same time it's
not going to be the case statistically
that like three lines of code are
executed for me and then three lines for
you and then three lines for you they're
probably going to get interspersed like
this gets executed for me and then this
gets executed for you and then they get
back to doing work for me and so forth
just to kind of multitask just like a
human might but at a super speed here
the problem though is if these lines of
code get interrupted what could go wrong
well suppose that Carter and I both
click the egg at the same time and
suppose the current number of likes back
in the day is 100 that stores in this
variable the value 100 but if we click
so close in time we might get back the
same answer to this select query as of
that moment in time when David and
Carter clicked it had a 100 likes but
then this last line of code is executed
for me and then maybe Carter because
that answer the state of the database
was stored in this variable then both
Carter and I will result in this line of
code being executed with the same value
update the post table setting the likes
equal to
101 for that post's ID why because again
if each of these lines of code running
on different servers are checking the
value of the current number of likes but
then getting interrupted because Carter
clicked the darn thing too and then
resuming their work on my behalf we
might have a race condition where the
code is sort of racing to finish but
getting interrupted by other users
clicks and the problem with that is that
if you are inspecting the value of some
variable or in this case a database cell
and making a decision based on it like
how to update it you might now lose data
and Instagram probably not good for
advertising if they're losing likes and
so that's probably a problem not to
retain the value 102 and instead insert
the number 101 twice it's actually
similar in spirit to a story that uh was
told in a databases course I took myself
years ago
whereby uh it's somewhat analogous to
kind of a contrived scenario involving
like a refrigerator and this is the
closest thing to a refrigerator we could
get on stage but imagine you've got like
one of these little dorm fridges in your
dorm 2 and your roommate and maybe both
of you as the story was told to me
really like milk and one of you is at
class but the other of you comes home
and you open your dorm fridge and you're
like oh darn it we're out of milk and so
you close the fridge you walk across the
street to CVS or some other store and
you get in line to buy some milk
Meanwhile your roommate gets out of
class they come back to your dorm room
they're really thirsty for some milk
they open up the fridge they say oh
we're out of milk and then they take a
different route perhaps to CVS or some
other store nearby get in line to buy
some milk fast forward some amount of
time in this very contrived story and
what happens oh damn it we now ended up
with two gallons of milk and there's no
way we can fit gallons of milk in there
let alone two of them so that's a
problem but what's the relationship to
this here well both of us yeah did
what
exactly
exactly so to summarize both of us had a
very similar thought process made a
similar decision based on the same
information not realizing that the
information the fridge was in the
process of being updated and of course
in the Instagram World happens like this
in the fridge World it might take a few
minutes but the problem is ultimately
the result of our having made a decision
about the state of the world and the
state of the world was in the middle of
being updated the queries got mingled
with others or in this case someone was
already on their way to the store so
what's the solution in the real world
well you could you know very simply like
take a Post-It note and put like gone
for milk so as to communicate to your
roommate that they should not inspect
the value of that variable and make a
decision on it why because it's not yet
consistent with the outcome that's about
to happen you could be more traumatic
and you could actually lock the fridge
somehow put a pad lock around it or the
like so they can't even get in there and
that would achieve the result uh the
same effect too and that is actually
pretty much the solution to this problem
in code too it's not safe it's not
sufficient to only execute three lines
of code like this rather what you
probably want to do is use additional
SQL keywords that we won't spend much
time on in the class itself but these
there are solutions to this problem you
can begin what's called a transaction
and you can more explicitly commit to
making a decision like updating the
database to 10 1001 or 10 1002 or if you
realize wait a minute Carter's query
inist interrupting mine let me roll back
to the previous state and just uh rewind
let me undo contrl Z if you will there's
also another keyword that's not so much
used anymore in SQL which is locking you
could literally back in the day lock the
entire database table preventing anyone
from updating it or making changes or
even reading it while someone else was
accessing it that was a very
heavy-handed solution because it slowed
everything down but in short
transactions are now a feature of SQL
that you won't necessarily need to use
yourselves that do solve this problem by
doing the equivalent of saying while
David's like counter is in the process
of being updated keep Carter at Bay
ideally briefly and then let his data go
through too it's equivalent too to
putting a note or a lock on the fridge
and indeed I mean lock litter they they
were Once Upon a Time called and still
are in some texts called locks on
databases 2 and the last Pro and the
code for which you might do this is
almost the same you simply wrap the
three queries uh with a transaction
statement and a uh commit and the term
of art here is that this makes your uh
your uh statements Atomic so Atomic
means they're either all executed or not
at all that is they're all very tightly
coupled together without interruption
transactions solves that problem and
avoid having two gallons of milk and the
last problem that arises that Is
tragically so darn common in the real
world today is what's called a SQL
injection attack and it's what I alluded
to earlier with the question mark So
suppose you're in the habit of logging
in uh to Yale websites with your net ID
or password or at Harvard your Harvard
key and password as well suppose for the
sake of discussion that the people that
implemented like Harvard key login allow
you to type in your email address of
course and your password but suppose
that they are using SQL underneath the
hood to check your username and password
to make sure that you are David menen or
Carter zeni or whoever you claim to be I
haven't shown you the syntax yet but it
turns out that in SQL Das Dash is a
special way of indicating a comment it
means ignore everything to the right so
it's just like SL slash and C or the
hash symbol in Python dash dash just
means ignore everything to the right and
we've of course seen single quotes So
one way to wage a SQL injection attack
is to try to inject malicious SQL code
into someone else's database without
them realizing it how do you do this
well suppose I log in as M harvard.edu
single quote Das Dash I'm not double
quoting anything clearly and there's
nothing to the right of the dash dash
anyway but it this imbalance is going to
be useful why because if I'm a hacker
and I'm presuming you know someone at
Harvard probably is using SQL uh single
quotes to wrap the user's email address
and wrap the user's password what if I
try to like complete their thought for
them and close one of those quotes for
them what might happen well we could do
this here for instance let me
hypothesize is the code that Harvard
wrote hopefully not underneath the hood
so they're using CS library and Python
and they're using SQL inside suppose
that they have a query like this select
star from users where username equals uh
question mark and password equals
question mark and then suppose they just
plug in whatever username and password
was typed in and then if they get back
some number of rows dot dot dot they
assume I am David they assume Carter is
Carter if both the username and password
are in the database just end of story
there this is good this has the question
mark placeholders we discussed earlier
but what if you don't quite remember
that you don't quite take that to heart
and you use your more familiar last week
F strings whereby we use these curly
braces to plug in values what if you do
this instead so it's almost the same
idea it's still DB execute but now it's
select star from users where username
equals and now notice I'm doing the
single quotes which is required by SQL
but I'm using F strings with the curly
braces and the password equals single
quote password and then close single
quote the problem is if you're just
blindly pasting equ effectively the
user's input into that web form into the
username field and the password field
there's nothing stopping a malicious
user student faculty staff from
including a single quote in their name
or maybe even an uh uh you know
benevolently if their name happens to
have a single quote as some last names
in particular do so this is very fragile
why well suppose that if we plug in my
malicious value Ma at harvard.edu single
quote-- notice what happens to username
here the username variable inside of the
curly quotes will get replaced with this
and notice single quote which the
Harvard programmer wrote M an
harvard.edu single quote which I wrote
dash dash which I wrote single quote
which Harvard wrote and whatever else
they want after that what's the
implication though of the dash
dash everything to the right is going to
be ignored so the password is never even
checked in this scenario I'm tricking
the server into ignoring everything
after the dash dash but I have
constructed very cleverly very
maliciously a syntactically valid query
why because I provided the single quote
that's going to finish the thought of
that first single quote and now I would
only know how to do this if I saw the
code or if I just randomly try putting
apostrophes into web forms and see if
things break that's often how
adversaries attack systems they type in
potentially dangerous characters hit
enter if something breaks they're not
necessarily into the system but they
know that there might be a vulnerability
and then they start trying more
methodically things like this so This
Then is going to be bad because it
effectively Grays out the rest of the
query and this query is surely going to
return some rows without even knowing my
password and so this logic here dot dot
dot means well if a data came back from
this query Harvard is presumably going
to assume that men logged in show them
uh show him like uh his account or
whatever is being protected here so in
short using F strings bad using any
equivalent like p uh percent s in C bad
when it comes to SQL using question
marks or whatever a thirdparty library
like cs50's prescribed is the way to
solve this why because libraries like
ours are designed to at least be smart
and be paranoid and what we will do is
this when you use the question marks and
the values are plugged in we will escape
any potentially dangerous characters
inside of those placeholders and so
effectively the single quote will no
longer be considered a grammatical
single quote it will just be literally a
character in the username or password so
the library takes care of this for you
because you're plugging in the username
and password as separate arguments and
then we or the third party you're using
actually sanitize that is uh clean up
the data and prevent those bad
characters now this is kind of an
internet meme that went around for a
while um if you've ever uh driven a car
been in a car where there's like the
automatic reader for tolls uh this
person thought it might be funny to try
doing something like this what are they
presumably doing the presumption here is
whether or not it worked as unclear is
that here's like the end of a actual
license plate number but here's an
interesting single quote and a semicolon
that's especially bad because it means
you can maybe execute a second query on
the database this is someone having fun
trying to drop the entire database table
for whatever municipality is scanning
through cameras uh their license plate
code and I would be remiss if we didn't
end on this note at least in computer
science circles um there is someone
named no relation to the TF name we put
in the database earlier um little Bobby
tables which ends with this XKCD
comic and if you chuckle if you laugh
you're now legit SQL
programmers nice
nice like every CS student out there
knows about little Bobby tables so if
you name drop little Bobby tables now
like you're in all right that's it
though for today we will see you next
[Music]
time
[Applause]
[Music]
all the way to the top and then you're
passing
down this is for you Yale we love you
Yale we're here to Har
go
har
[Applause]
down it's going to
happen it's actually going to happen I
can't believe this what do you think of
Y they don't think
good can't does everyone have it does
everyone have their stuff does everyone
have their stuff probably that it's
going to beable very
small I
know what
houses how many exra how many
EXT no F forer yeah just make sure
everyone
has pass all the car distributed
all right we can do it
[Applause]
[Music]
now
what do you think of Y
sir go go one more time one
[Applause]
more there goes
again
[Applause]
all right this is cs50 welcome to week 8
last week we learned how to create read
update and delete databases using squl
but this
week Adam everyone happy
Halloween all right so this is cs50 and
this is week eight already my thanks to
Adam on today this happy Halloween uh in
the coming moments we're going to learn
all about how the internet itself Works
which of course is a technology that
like we're all take we all use every day
probably using in some form right now
but we'll see that if you start to
understand some of the underlying
building blocks that power the internet
itself we can actually start to build
interesting things on top of it and a
lot of the apps the websites that you
all use every day should become all the
more familiar things that you yourself
VES can create and honestly when things
go wrong you'll have all the more of a
mental model for how things work or are
not in fact working so that you can
ultimately diagnose diagnose all the
more issues yourselves so if we take a
look at the internet in the early days
it pretty much was just this this
happens to be of course the geography of
the United States and just some of the
first uh points on the internet were
these here this was so-called arpanet
back in 1969 and indeed the internet had
its Origins here in the United States
with just a few computers interconnect
somehow initially that of course began
to grow over time such that we
eventually had the West Coast connected
to the east coast and nowadays what you
can think of these dots on the screen is
representing are these things called
routers sort of computers or really
servers that somehow have wires or maybe
wireless connections between them that
allow data to flow from point A to B to
C and then this of course has been now
magnified across the entire Globe um and
even above ground as well so that we can
connect all the more readily uh to
systems anywhere now in order to Route
the data from one router to another we
need to somehow make routing decisions
and this is the kind of thing that the
internet service providers the isps of
the world just handle for us you and I
plug our Macs our PCS into the network
here at Harvard or equivalently at Yale
or we somehow get online via Wi-Fi or
cellular technology and then some of
these larger entities these bigger
companies or countries handle most of
the data getting from point A to point B
and if you think about what these
routers present they're indeed just
servers somehow interconnected not
unlike this grid of tiles here for
instance back in the zoom days and in
fact here we have I claim a grid of
routers implemented here by the courses
teaching fellows and course assistants
and Tas and if the goal at hand for
instance is for Phyllis to Route some
piece of information maybe it's an email
maybe it's a request for a web page in
the bottom right hand corner all the way
up to say Brian here in the top left
hand corner suffice it to say each each
of these tiles represents a router a
server that can move the data back forth
left and right that packet of
information so to speak from Phyllis to
Brian could take any number of different
possible routes up down left right to go
from the one corner to another so let me
go ahead and hit play on this video here
we're in the teaching fellows play the
same
[Music]
role
all right so in this particular case the
data was routed pretty straightforwardly
up and then to the left but suppose that
one or more of the staff were a bit busy
maybe one of the routers is congested
that is to say just got way more
envelopes at a moment in time that it
can handle thankfully the design of the
internet is such that there's often
multiple ways that data can get from
point A to point B maybe going through
Point C or Point D instead and so
there's a resilience there even as some
of these servers themselves might go
down so allow me to propose that we use
the same grid of routers now to Route
the data in a slightly different way
this
[Music]
[Applause]
time
so success you'll see perhaps later just
how many takes it took us to actually
get that routing right but it does in
fact manifest that you can uh travel
different paths in order to get the data
from point A to point B so as we talk
about routers as you think of the
internet I mean think of those humans as
just representing these routers points a
to p and everywhere in between now how
did the teaching staff know to route
that packet up and then down or left and
right in order to get get to the
destination well all of them were
programmed so to speak to understand
protocols it's called TCP and IP
Otherwise Known together typically as
tcpip and you've probably seen these
acronyms at some point in the real world
on the internet on some kind of
documentation a text even if you haven't
really thought hard about it but IP is
certainly the more common of the two
perhaps in common culture so what does
TCP and IP do for us well really two
primary things any computer or any
teaching staff member who understands
tcpip knows how to get data from point A
to point B but how well let's break down
what that problem to be solved is IP
otherwise known as Internet Protocol is
a protocol that computers speak that
allow them to know how to address
computers on the internet and a protocol
is just a set of conventions that
computers adhere to so someone wrote
code that probably has a whole lot of
conditionals that tells the computer
what to do if something happens like if
I receive a packet then send it to the
next server or something like that in
the human world we have protocols too
you know pre in healthier times it was
quite common to sort of extend your hand
to another human in order to greet them
and if they're following human protocol
they would presumably grab your hand and
shake it at least in a a culture like
this one here on campus and now that is
a human protocol in that someone
initiates it someone responds to it and
you both sort of know what to do you're
programmed to know what to do so same
idea with Internet Protocol computers
just know what to do when they've been
programmed to do so so what does this
mean IP had decides that every compter
computer in the world will have a unique
address just like uh a the science
center around the corner might have a
unique address of one Oxford Street
Cambridge Massachusetts 02138 USA IP
dictates that every computer on the
internet have a unique address of this
form and this too is probably something
you've seen in the real world even if
you haven't thought too hard about it
it's a number and what's called dotted
decimal notation which means it's a
decimal number do something do something
do something so four digits separated by
convention by decimal points although
there are newer and bigger versions of
the same and these so-called IP
addresses that might be as simple as
1.2.3.4 uniquely identify a computer on
the internet uh the numbers have to
range from 0 to 255 each and that's a
bit of a hint just as you start to think
more computationally if each of these is
a number from 0 to 255 how many bits
does that suggest each number is
using feel free to shout it
out how many bits gives us 255 256 total
possibilities so eight bits that should
just be sort of a heuristic in your mind
anytime you hear something that's in the
range of 0 to 255 or 256 values total
think back to week zero which gives us
eight bits plus another eight bits
another eight bits and another eight
bits which is to say an IP address
typically is 32 bits in total now if we
do another bit of quick mental math or
think back to week zero if every IP
address is 32 bits how many computers
can we have on the
internet at once give or take
roughly 4 billion is the ballpark and we
don't need to be super precise for
discussion's sake but roughly 4 billion
is how high you can account assuming no
negative numbers if you have 32 bits in
total now that's not terribly uh many
number uh numbers of addresses
especially considering the number of
humans in the world the number of us
that do have laptops or desktops or
devices more generally phones in our
pockets and the like so let me just
stipulate for today's purposes that
there's even a newer and improved
version of Ip otherwise known as version
6 this is version four but still super
popular version six uses 128 bits which
is a huge number of possible
premutations I dare say I can't even
pronounce that number it's so big so
there are ways around even this
limitation already so every computer has
an address like this what does that
really mean well suppose that I was
Phyllis in the story told visually
earlier and I want to send a message to
Brian well both Phyllis and Brian have I
IP addresses and suppose that Brian's IP
address happens to be 1.2.3.4 in that
top left hand corner well phyllis's Mac
or PC or phone would essentially do the
equivalent on this human envelope by
writing the two address in the middle of
the envelope as is our human convention
like this so this is an envelope a piece
of information an email a text message
whatever destined for Brian and so she
would have her computer put Brian's IP
address in the middle her IP address is
Maybe 5.6.7 do8 so just like our human
convention I might write 5.
6.7.8 at the top of the envelope
5678 thereby indicating what the return
address is and this is helpful because
if Brian's computer needs to acknowledge
receipt if he needs to reply in some
form this way the envelope has all the
information we need but in the real
world servers do a lot of things
nowadays not just email but maybe chat
Maybe video conferencing maybe any
number of other services as well and so
it turns out that an address alone might
not be sufficient because how do how
does Brian's computer know when he opens
the envelope so to speak that this
should be interpreted as an email or
interpret it as a chat message or
interpret it as like a video attachment
that Phyllis has sent well we need some
other mechanism some other hint on this
envelope to distinguish one type of
Internet service from another and so
that's where the other acronym in TCI
pip comes in which is TCP so this stands
for transmission control protocol which
is just a different set of conventions
that computers adhere to in order to
solve a couple of different problems one
is this problem of distinguishing one
type of service from another now what
does that mean well humans decades ago
decided as they started inventing all of
these various internet services the web
being the first one how they might or
the web now being one of the most
popular ones they decided to assign
different services that can be used on
the internet unique numbers and so two
of the most common are these 80 is the
number that a bunch of humans decided
years ago will represent what you and I
know as HTTP and we'll talk more
technically in a bit about what HTTP is
but obviously it's the thing that's in
the beginning of every URL nowadays or
https which of course has the S added to
it and that has its own unique number
and for now the S just means secure one
is encrypted or scrambled somehow for
privacy sake and the other is
unencrypted it's a little more
vulnerable to interception so these two
numbers are what the world decided when
implementing TCP shall uniquely identify
those services so what does this mean
well this means that if Brian's computer
in the story from before is hosting not
like an email server but maybe he has a
website and Phyllis is requesting
Brian's homepage or something like that
she would have her Mac or PC or phone
not only write Brian's IP address in the
middle of the envelope but also the
number otherwise known as a port number
that she wants this envelope to be
routed to now 80 would be insecure
nowadays HTTP col is sort of p and we
almost always see https colon now so I'm
just going to go with best practice and
I'm going to add a colon and then the
number
443 at the end of Brian's IP address so
now I have an IP address for Brian the
port number for the service that this is
relevant to and I'm not going to bother
writing it but it turns out that
phyllis's computer would also choose a
port number maybe a random port number
so that Brian can conversely reply and
then the computer can know which
response is in uh coming back for which
request but the most important one is
this one in the two field whereby this
distinguishes this from like an email a
chat message a video conference session
or a zoom or whatnot from anything else
happening on Brian's computer at the
same time so all this time if you've
seen these terms TCP and IP those are
really two of the most important things
that they do but TCP does one other
thing that's super useful too it turns
out that it's
super common nowadays especially to
transmit a lot of media on the internet
internet whether it's an image or maybe
it's a movie file and it would be a
little obnoxious to say the least if
you're downloading a really big file
meant that no one else in your dorm room
or your household could actually
download anything until you're actually
done so of course multiple people
nowadays can be on the internet at once
even if all of the connections are a
little slower but like one person's
usage does not block someone else's now
how does this work well TCP in
conjunction with IP can also allow you
to take like a really big image of a cat
which is the internet of course is
filled with and take a big image of a
cat or a big video file of a cat and
fragment it into multiple pieces so I'm
just going to sort of roughly tear it
down the middle and then maybe tear it
down the middle again so now it's four
different fragments and I'm I'm sorry
but the computer will be reassembling
these for us and what phyllis's computer
could do now if she's like uploading
this picture of a cat to Brian's web
server well she could put one fragment
in this envelope and then have three
separate envelopes for the other three
fragments and what you could then do on
the outside of this envelope is just
kind of number them somehow and in fact
this is something else that TCP and IP
together would do for us this first
envelope now might say something like
one out of four in the memo field so to
speak of the uh metaphorical envelope
here now this should be enough
information because now if Brian gets
all four of these envelopes he
presumably knows how to reassemble the
picture of the cat in order top to
bottom left to right but more
importantly suppose that one of the
routers one of the TFS in the video is
sort of distracted and they sort of drop
one of the packets and that's a metaphor
actually in practice for when a router
gets really busy it's got way too much
data coming in it might metaphorically
drop packets what does that mean in
practice I mean it literally just
ignores the zeros and ones it doesn't
save them to its memory because there's
just no room left so it's equivalent to
sort of dropping the packet so suppose
now that Brian gets one of four three of
four and four of four what can his
computer infer
now after receiving those three packets
one of four three of four and four of
four what's the use there yeah I think
you're you're signaling with your
fingers which one did which one can I
call on you yeah so he's missing two out
of four the second of the packets and
this is useful now because you could
imagine he can send some message back to
Phyllis saying hey please retransmit
number two of four without having to
redownload the entirety of the cat so
there's there's an efficiency there as
well so tcpip allows data really to go
from point A to point B while solving a
bunch of these problems along the way so
nowadays if you ever see mention on your
Mac or PC of your so-called IP address
that is the sort of problem that's being
solved questions now on these protocols
these conventions called TCP and
IP that's the extent to which we'll need
to understand them won't have to
implement them per se we'll just take
them Hereafter for
granted any questions that you've ever
been wondering wondering about your home
network
yeah a really good question uh how does
TCP know that a user got a message
another aspect another feature of TCP is
that Brian's computer by design of this
protocol will also acknowledge the
packets that he's received and it will
do it efficiently if Brian receives all
four packets in a pretty narrow window
of time his computer will send to
phyllis's computer a quick message
saying essentially received all four
otherwise he'll say the opposite which
is that I'm missing for for instance two
out of four and that just ensures
ultimately that all of the data is
indeed uh arrived so that you're not
missing like uh a quarter a quadrant of
the cat in question all right but th
that's not the only problem that needs
to be solved ultimately we also need to
make the internet userfriendly if you
will and it would be really tedious if
you had to visit websites for instance
by way of of their IP addresses right
1.2.3.4 is pretty memorable but there's
like 4 billion other possible addresses
available and it would be super tedious
to remember those it would be bad
marketing to advertise those in fact
most of you probably don't even know the
phone numbers of your closest friends
and family members anymore because you
instead store them in your contacts
you're in your dress book associating
with numbers that are completely opaque
with actual names or strings if you will
the same is goes for the internet too
even though every computer does have and
must have a unique IP address
numerically why well routers or
computers computers just crunch numbers
very readily but we humans work better
with strings of text we need some system
for converting userfriendly strings like
harvard.edu or yale.edu or google.com to
the underlying IP addresses and that's
where the next acronym comes in today
which is DNS domain name system so this
is just another technology that's been
in use for some time now and it's a
collection of servers on the internet
that whose purpose in life is to convert
domain names to IP addresses and maybe
vice versa as well so let me stipulate
for today's purposes there are some root
DNS servers in the world that long story
short know about all of the Dooms all of
the edus all of the dot dot dot all of
the other top level domains around the
world as well as in the US and then
there are some smaller DNS servers owned
by companies owned by universities and
even in your apartments or homes most
likely indeed if you have a home router
plugged into the wall somewhere that's
not only routing your data in and out of
your apartment or home or dorm room it's
also typically serving as a local
therefore faster DNS server a cash if
you will it's sort of locally saving
your most frequently accessed websites
and their IP addresses just to avoid
bothering the bigger more expensive
busier servers all day long so there's
DNS servers all over if you poke around
your settings in Windows or Mac OS or
Android or iOS you'll see mention of DNS
and you'll probably see the IP addresses
of the servers whose purpose in life is
to do this conversion for you but this
is a requisite feature if we just want
the internet to be user friendly and
allow us to use words instead of numbers
alone what's inside of these DNS servers
you know it's essentially a spreadsheet
or if we can say it more geeky it's
essentially like a hash table of some
sort which it has keys and values like
the key is the domain name harvard.edu
gale. edug google.com and the value is
the corresponding IP address or in many
cases IP addresses plural of the
corresponding servers so here already
even though I've drawn it fairly
abstractly like you would on a
chalkboard it's really probably
implemented as some kind of table maybe
a hash table maybe a database table
maybe SQL or something like that or
maybe it's even just a link list or an
array we just have to somehow enable
this computer to convert one to the
other now just to be super precise
DNS servers actually convert what are
called fully qualified domain names
which is generally not just harvard.edu
but more verbosely
www.harvard.edu and
www.google.com so the whole thing that
you would see as a substring of the URL
so that's what DNS does and that's what
your University your company your home
router are doing for you let me pause
here to see if there are any
questions this to is just a technology
now we'll take for granted just
works questions at all all right so
let's now transition among our protocols
really to the last for today which will
set the stage for actually solving
problems with these and writing some
code ultimately um HTTP this is
something that you see or hear all day
long even though you rarely have to
bother typing it anymore odds are if you
go to harvard.edu yale.edu google.com
you don't bother typing HTTP let alone
https manually anymore why because your
browser Auto completes that kind of
thing just to make life easier but it is
officially at the beginning of every URL
you visit either HTTP or the more secure
https whenever you're using your browser
to access some website so
HTTP stands for hyper text transfer
protocol and it's uh easily one of the
most popular dare say one of the most
powerful features of the internet
nowadays but the mental model to have
here is that HTTP or the web more
generally is kind of a service that runs
on top of the internet and maybe Zoom or
Microsoft teams is another service that
runs on top of the internet an iMessage
and Technologies like it is another
service that runs on top of the internet
so the internet is really like the lower
level Plumbing the tcpip stuff the DNS
stuff that just gets data from point A
to point B but now and we're in a a
software development class ultimately
here in cs50 HTTP is the application
Level protocol it's sort of what
programmers use what companies use what
uh developers use ultimately to use the
underlying Plumbing to build interesting
and Powerful things so what does this
mean when it comes to accessing Services
via HTTP or the more secure
https well here is a representative URL
even though you might not type the whole
thing if you poke around your address
bar this is what's up there with that
said a lot of browsers nowadays are kind
of simplifying if not dumbing down what
you see with your human eyes just to
shorten the strings especially on mobile
devices but almost always if you click
the URL or highlight it then you see the
whole thing but on many browsers you
might only ever see example.com but all
of this information is there it's just
getting more and more hidden just for
user interfaces sake well it turns out
when you visit a URL by default
especially if you type nothing after the
do com in this case you're technically
implicitly adding a single slash so a
single slash denotes the root of the
server that is the default page or
folder in the server and the slash
whether or not you type it or not is
implicitly going to be there and that
just means give me the default whatever
is at www.example.com give me that page
or that folder but URLs can be longer
than this and more generally there can
be a path so to speak and this is a term
of art a path is some sequence of folder
Andor file names after a URL like this
and so you might see more specifically
that a URL contains a very specific file
this isn't as common nowadays anymore
though we will begin to today by using
this technique but if there is a file
called literally file. HTML or something
else on the server that file is going to
be what this URL pulls up on the
computer meanwhile you might have slash
folder slash which just means show me
whatever is inside of this folder or you
might have more verbosely folder file.
HTML which will show you that file in
that folder and meanwhile just to give
some other terms of art this is the
so-called fully qualified domain name
and again these vocab don't matter all
that much but you'll hear or see them
over time we generally colloquially just
refer to this as the domain name which
is a little less precise but gets the
job done certainly in conversation and
this part here I described briefly
earlier what's the name for this suffix
at the very end of the fully qualified
domain
name the yeah yeah top level domain or
TLD and this is just some form of
categorization of the URLs now the
internet in got it start within the
United States and a lot of the first
websites of course came from the US and
so For Better or For Worse the sort of
steak was planted in the ground so
generally do indicated at least early on
that it was some kind of commercial
Enterprise a business that owned a
domain name edu is a educational
institution net was some kind of
network. goov was the US government now
there are also country code tlds cctlds
like UK or JP every country in the world
has its own two letter uh TLD um that
might very well be restricted to only
servers or companies or people in that
uh in that country many of them can be
used by anyone you've used a lot of URLs
in this class ending in
cs50. that doesn't mean input output um
it actually is a TLD from another
country that lets anyone on the internet
um pay for and on an annual basis using
that domain. TV for instance you might
see in some cases like twitch.tv and the
like um that too is owned by another
country that allows others in the
English-speaking World in this case to
use it as though it connotes TV but
those are just different types of TLS
that roughly categorize where the domain
lives but it doesn't necessarily mean
it's commercial anymore it doesn't
necessarily mean it's a Network anymore
for the most part there are hundreds of
tlds now for better for worse most of
which are less common than these big
ones um but most anyone can buy most of
them with just some restrictions on
things like edu and goov that are still
very much regulated this meanwhile is
what we might call the host name www
it's obviously a super common convention
like almost every website uses www as
its host name but that's a human
convention it's not a requirement and
indeed some websites don't even bother
having a host name they just use their
domain to advertise their websites this
now is going to be the scheme or the
protocol and this is just going to
indicate via what protocol the computer
your Mac your PC your phone should use
when accessing content at that address
because indeed there are other protocols
you can use but for the most part
will'll only focus on HTTP or
equivalently
https all right any questions now on
those just definitions building blocks
of URLs just so we all sort of share a
common
vocabulary any questions at all yeah
what is the
local sure we'll come back to this
actually later today there's a a
technical term known as Local Host which
is a generic name for your computer your
Mac your PC your phone especially when
you're doing software development and by
convention your own computer has not
only whatever IP address you get from
your University or your internet service
provider it also has a reflexive IP
address one that just always refers to
itself which is 127.0.0.1 and that's
just a human convention humans decided
that shall refer always to your computer
and it's actually going to be useful
today and onward because we can use that
when development on our own computers
ultimately other questions on URLs IP
DNS or any of these building
blocks all right so what do we mean by
HTTP being a protocol when I extended my
hand earlier as a human handshake you
know a typical human in healthy times
would know to respond in turn well how
does Brian's computer know to respond to
phyllis's envelope whatever message is
they're in well assuming that Brian is
indeed still a web server in the store
and Phyllis was trying to upload a cat
or maybe download a cat from Brian's web
server inside of phyllis's envelope
would have been a message literally in
text and it's English for the most part
and it would contain at the beginning of
that message literally one of these
English verbs either get which means
just that get me the homepage get me a
picture of a cat get me a picture of a
dog or a video or anything else or post
which often means post that is um put
that is um upload a picture of a cat or
a dog or something else to the server
instead that's not strictly the only use
cases for these but you can generally
think them as one is just getting
information and the other is posting
from the client from Phyllis to the
server in this case Brian so those are
the two keywords that we might see and
why is this useful well it turns out we
can start to see in our own Mac or PC
some of these very same messages for
instance if Phyllis were visiting not
Brian's but example.com that web server
inside of her metaphorical envelope
there would be a textual message that
literally starts with get slash then the
word HTTP then the version she's using
1.1 is very common two and three are
becoming more common but HTTP generally
looks like this the next line of text in
her envelope would probably say host
colon then literally the fully qualified
domain name of the server she's
accessing just in case and this happens
super commonly especially on small
websites if one server is hosting
multiple domain names multiple websites
this just distinguishes which one she
actually wants and then there's usually
a whole bunch of other lines of text as
well so where can you actually see this
well let me actually go ahead and do
this give me just a moment and I'm going
to open up on my computer here uh an
empty Chrome window in incognito mode
generally speaking incognito mode or
private mode is used when you don't want
there to be left remnants of what
websites you visited and it has the
effect for software developers of just
forgetting any things you might have
tried already within your browser
including things called cookies more on
those another time uh your autocomplete
history and the like so for development
purposes incognito mode is especially
helpful because it's sort of like
starting with a clean slate every time
you open a new private or incognito mode
so there's not going to be like any
remnants of previous testing or code
that you've been playing with and I'm
going to go ahead and do this I'm going
to go ahead and uh right click or
control click on Chrome I'm going to
choose inspect and it's going to pull up
this window sometimes on the side
sometimes on the bottom I'm going to
move it to the bottom just so we can see
it a little more readily and I'm going
to zoom in and it's going to look a
little Arcane at first and I'm going to
just highlight a few of these tabs we'll
see here along the top that there's
elements console sources Network and
whole bunch of other things as well this
is sort of the advanced mode in Chrome
and Safari and Firefox and Edge have
their own equivalent of these features
they've always been there even if you've
never clicked the right button to enable
these features and I'm going to focus
for a moment on network like this
this is a feature of the browser that's
going to allow me the programmer in this
case so the the engineer to just kind of
look at what messages my browser is
actually sending to a server so let me
go ahead and do something like this let
me go ahead and visit uh for instance uh
in my browser here and I'm going to
shrink the window just a little bit so
we can see it exactly I'm going to visit
https uh
www.harvard.edu and now I'm going to hit
enter
and a whole bunch of stuff just happened
along the bottom of my screen and I'm
going to try to pull my window up just a
little bit so we can focus on a subset
of this let me pull this up covering up
really the content of the page focusing
on these lower level details down here
and what I want to see first
is let me oh sorry let me go ahead and
reload this page here after retaining
the log so that we can see absolutely
everything on the screen and to be clear
I just checked because I forgot earlier
preserve log because I wanted to
preserve everything on the screen I want
to see everything all at once and we'll
see this the very first line of output
is completely overwhelming with detail
at first glance but what you'll see here
if I start to scroll down and down and
down and down are the so-called request
headers and let me zoom in here and what
you're seeing inside of chrome inside of
its Network tab in its so-called
developer tools again this is just for
engineering types you'll see all of the
headers all of the lines of text that
magically were sent by my Mac to
harvard.edu much like from Phyllis to
Brian server in that story so I can see
exactly what messages are being sent and
a lot of this we haven't talked about
yet but we do see some mention of get
and we see some mention of Slash and a
bunch of other Arcane details but notice
they're all sort of key value pairs with
the here indicating what the
corresponding value is now most of this
is not going to be interesting and we're
not going to focus too much on the weeds
of of all of this but it indeed gives us
a sense of what's inside of that virtual
envelope now harvard.edu is one thing
but there's other uh websites we might
visit as well um and no matter what they
are we're going to expect ultimately an
HTTP response so in addition to a
computer like my Mac or phyllis's
computer sending a request containing
gets and host and those details too
you'll see here in my slide form just
representative response from the server
and notice that key here is that the
server is responding in the same version
of HTTP in this example it's sending
back this so-called status code just a
numeric code that indicates in this case
that everything's okay and it includes
this header this HTTP header which again
is just a key value pair saying that the
type of this content that's coming back
from the server is text/html more on
HTML in just a little bit but for our
purposes now this just means that
harvard.edu is sending me back a web
page and indeed if we hide all of this
techn techical stuff that's the web page
that we saw up here with all of the
usual imagery and the like and in fact I
can see this if I scroll back up not to
request headers but response headers
you'll see up here that we get back
responses including the date that the
server responded and a whole bunch of
other details as well and honestly this
has always been under your fingertips
and it will soon be useful as we start
making web-based applications ultimately
but this very quickly gets overwhelming
quickly and so better in this might
actually be a tool that we can use
within our code space itself so let me
go back to vs code here I didn't open
any code tabs I'm just going to use my
terminal window for a moment and I'm
going to run a couple of commands that
are going to allow me to actually see
what is going on when I request one
website let me go ahead and use a
command called curl for connect URL and
this is like a command line black and
white program that's going to pretend to
be a browser and it's going to connect
to the URL show me the headers but it's
not going to show me the images are the
graphics which might very well be useful
to the humans but not to me right now as
the developer so I'm going to do curl
I'm going to do Dashi and then I'm going
to do
https www.harvard.edu as though I'm
pretending to be a browser requesting
the home page and what's nice about curl
is albeit overwhelming too you'll get
back a whole response from the server
containing only those header values the
key value pairs inside of the envelope
and we'll ignore almost all of these but
here is the response from the server it
responded using a new and improved
version of HTTP in this case version two
and it gave me back a 200 there's my
content type text/html and then this
Char set happens to do with the encoding
if it's Unicode or asky or something
else and then there's all this other
overwhelming detail for now but this is
the beginnings of my ability to just
kind of poke around and see how the
server works and it turns out too that
we'll be able to see other potential
responses as well so for instance uh
HTTP might not only return 100 what if I
do this instead let me go ahead and
visit c-i
HTTP
colon uh www.harvard.edu so notice I
deliberately use the insecure version of
the URL which maybe Harvard's
Administration system administration
doesn't like anymore well how can they
ensure that I the end user the student
nonetheless use
https even if I didn't type it myself
well let me run just that command with
just HTTP not https and you'll see that
everything is not okay it didn't come
back with a 200 it came back with 301 in
this message saying Harvard moved
permanently but here's where you can
look for another clue among all of these
lines most of which I don't care about
there's a location header colon that's a
little hint to me that says where
Harvard University has apparently moved
too on the web and what's different
about this URL just to be
clear it has the S included and what
your browser will do by default because
Google and Microsoft and Mozilla
programmed it this way whenever it sees
a 301 response instead of 200 it won't
show you any web page it will look for a
location header find that URL and then
automatically quote unquote redirect you
there to so this is why it doesn't
matter what we type in the browser
Harvard can have its server send these
semi-secret messages to our browsers and
then it will just visit a second URL all
automatically and you can do this with
host names as well suppose that Harvard
does not want to standardize on
harvard.edu why they just want it to
always be www maybe it's a branding
thing maybe it's a technical thing we
can see the exact same response here
this first tells me when I visit HTTP
harvard.edu with no www Harvard
minimally wants me to be using a secure
connection if I then okay fine cooperate
let me go ahead and clear my screen let
me add the s but not the www you can see
here that it again responded with 301 up
here and the location now adds the www
so it's just a way of bouncing users
from one place to another and this is
all thanks to http boiling down to
relatively simple messages inside of the
envelope that tell the computer the
browser in this case how to respond now
odds are you've seen others besides 301
even though you've probably never seen
that actual number unless you've done
this kind of thing before but there
probably is a number that like everyone
in this room has seen if if You' never
really wondered why is it that number I
think you're smiling what number are you
thinking of yeah so 404 why is 404 well
404 indicates by convention not found
and now why the world decided years ago
to show us normal humans on the internet
404 is anything significant is unclear
that's sort of like bad design like what
do I care if the status code is 404 but
it's common enough on the internet that
probably all of us have seen it but that
just means that some server when you
visit a URL that's incorrect maybe it's
outdated the URL has been changed if you
see a 404 it just means that the virtual
envelope that came from the server back
to your Mac or PC or phone contains not
200 okay not 301 moved permanently but
404 not found instead and it's usually
accompanied by a technical message maybe
a cute picture of a cat sort of hiding
because it means not found or something
like that the Aesthetics are entirely up
to the server but that's what the 404
means and there's other codes too a few
of which you'll use in the coming weeks
as we transition from commandline
programs in C and python to web-based
ones we've seen a few of these already
and several of them are kind of variants
of the same thing like these 300 ones
here but we'll see others like 403
Forbidden means like you probably forgot
to log in or you need to log in or
something like that uh internal server
error right now no in the coming weeks
you will absolutely encounter 500 errors
and they're always your fault it's going
to be the equivalent of like a
segmentation fault in C a 500 error
means like you or I screwed up when
writing some code so we're going to see
that but it's just going to be an
opportunity for us to fix it if a
server's overloaded you often see 503
like something's unavailable because
something's too popular uh or is maybe
worse getting attacked um this is an old
uh um April Fool's joke 418 is not
actually used in practice but someone
like took the time to write up an entire
formal text technical proposal so that
servers can respond saying I'm a teapot
so it's kind of part of Internet lore
and there's other ones of these status
codes as well but this is useful because
eventually we'll see in code you can use
this understanding uh high level as it
might be of HTTP to do some interesting
and Powerful things so for instance we
can even send fancier URLs to servers it
turns out as we'll soon see if you send
a message like this get/ search question
question mark Q equals cats and then
HTTP 1.1 or whatever version and you
send that message to Google server
www.google.com this is how you can
specify not just the path of a web page
that you want SL search in this case the
question mark it turns out is going to
be a convention in the internet in the
web specifically for passing hum human
uh user input to the server as well in
fact you've probably never paid close
attention to URLs but they very often
have question question marks they very
often have equal signs and indeed even
google.com supports a certain key Q in
this case for query and you can put
anything you want after that in order to
search for actual cats so if I actually
go back to Chrome itself here for a
moment let me pull back my uh pull back
open my Chrome browser here previously I
was using uh incognito mode for
harvard.edu I've gone ahead and Clos
that window and opened a new one so we
can start fresh by visiting Google
normally you and I are in the habit of
going to google.com and searching via
the form or nowadays you just type like
your search query in the browser itself
and it brings you automatically to
Google or Bing or something else but I
can really be pedantic here let me go
ahead and zoom in and I'll manually go
to
https
www.google.com search question mark Q
equals maybe cats now this would not be
a very userfriendly experience if all of
us had to manually type out something
crazy like that but that's what the form
is redirecting you to when you type in
more user friendly cats into like a text
box if I hit enter here we'll get back
indeed a whole bunch of search results
about cats if I zoom back in and maybe I
change it from cats to dogs that too is
going to change and notice it's
pre-populating the text box because
Google has written its code in order to
do so as well now appr propo of the
video with which we began today from
yester year one of the better uh Yale
pranks over the years um has anyone one
actually ever been to uh
safetyschool.org
and to our friends at Yale watching live
hi safetyschool.org so it's kind of fun
if you actually visit it uh depending on
who you are so if I open up a new window
here and I go to
https
safetyschool.org zooming
in enter my oh my look at where it goes
now how does that okay okay thank
you this is not a cs50 thing someone out
there who I don't know who they are for
like 20 years has been paying annually
for that domain safetyschool.org for
just this joke uh but if I now go back
into VSS code here in my terminal window
and a little more you know
sophisticatedly let me do curl dasi HTTP
col andsafety
school.org the browser of course
immediately redirected me to the website
but what's going on under underneath the
hood well 20 some years ago someone
bought the domain configured the server
quite simply to spit this out safety
school.org for years has moved
permanently to
www.yale.edu so just a little
demonstration of what you can do with
just a little bit of understanding of
HTTP that's been a lot already we've
laid the foundation for understanding
how the internet works now we're going
to use it with a language called HTML
hypertext markup language CSS cascading
stylesheets and JavaScript a proper
program in language but first it feels
opportune to take a 10-minute break we
have some wonderful Halloween candy in
the transcept and we'll be back in 10
with those
languages we're headed up to uh
Austin checking out the stadium for the
prank a few years ago I was at a math
conference and I was sitting around at
the table at dinner with a few other
mathematicians and uh one of them went
to Harvard and started telling the story
of this amazing prank that was you know
against Harvard and at that point I felt
I had to interrupt and said well
actually I can tell you a lot more about
that okay okay the idea was perfected in
a dorm room came up with the idea
actually to prank them with signs at the
football game we threw some ideas out
there as far as what what the signs
would say we uh eventually settled on we
suck and my immediate reaction was no
this will never work however the problem
solver in me started thinking well maybe
we can make this
work the problem they had to infiltrate
Harvard Stadium without getting caught
sneak in 1,800 placards distribute them
to unsuspecting Harvard fans and then
convince those fans to prank themselves
it's great we thought about basically
every possible thing that could go wrong
and tried to come up with a solution for
it and then you put two Reds on top of
it they made fake Harvard IDs and fake
backstories
fake placard designs and a 28 member
fake Pep
Squad on November 20th 2004 a fake
Harvard student smuggled the placards
into the game what do you think
[Music]
[Applause]
of but then trouble what houses
how many how many extra
are I you know just showed him the front
of this ID and all of a sudden he just
ran away and he felt so
embarrassed having escaped one
confrontation they couldn't risk another
it was
time this just looks like a total mess
we have absolutely no idea if this is
going to work look at the it's going to
happen it's actually going to
happen I can't believe this what was
once a
prank became a
legend and immediately we started
hearing chance from the other side
you and I think it was at that point in
time that we knew we had pulled it
off on
there it goes
[Applause]
again I really think it didn't matter
that Harvard won because of the prank
for a lot of Yale students in alumni we
definitely won that
[Music]
year all right
happy
Hallen thank you all okay thank you oh
here oh all right little Halloween candy
all right thank you all so glad I wore
the same thing
today so in just a
moment thank you okay so in just a
moment we'll transition to understanding
all the now what we can do with this
underlying infrastructure so again HTTP
and below it TCP IP is all about just
getting the data from point A to pointb
in some standardized way but now let's
talk about HTML this is the language in
which web pages themselves are written
hyper text markup language now some of
you might have used this before to make
personal homepages some of you might
have dabbled even if using some website
to create your own homepage but
understanding this language is useful
certainly for creating the Aesthetics of
a web page can vying data that's of
interest but at the end of the day it
and the language we look at next CSS uh
are not programming languages there's
going to be no functions no Loops uh no
programming logic but we will end today
with a teaser of a proper programming
language called JavaScript via which you
can manipulate all of these various uh
other languages as well so ultimately
HTML has like two features and this is a
language that we spend very brief amount
of time on because it really boils down
to just a couple of basic ideas and then
vocabulary that you'll build out over
time just by Googling looking up
references looking at other Pages source
code but tags and attributes are what
characterize HTML now what do I mean by
that here for instance is the HTML code
via which you can make probably the
simplest of all web pages one that quite
simply says in the uh browser window
hello title and hello body for instance
now what does this actually mean if you
imagine opening up uh this code in a
browser be it on a Mac or PC or phone
you'll see typically like some kind of
rectangular window and there's usually a
tab that has the title of that page and
then most of the rectangular region is
the web page itself what you're looking
at then is the code that's going to put
hello title in the title bar in the tab
at the very top and down at the bottom
hello body is going to be all that's in
the big black and white box that
composes the rest of the browser window
itself now what are the Salient
characteristics here that we'll now
start to take for granted well first
whoops uh first let's go ahead and give
me just a moment here um and actually do
something with this code so I'm going to
go ahead and do this back in vs code
here I'm going to first create a file
called say hello.html and in this tab
I'm going to go ahead and really repeat
exactly that same code now I had this
line first DOC type HTML then I had this
line HTML Lang equals quote unquote n
close quote then I had inside of that
head then I had inside of that title
then inside of that I had hello title
and I'm doing this quickly because we'll
tease apart in a moment what it actually
all means and then down here below that
so-called head I had just the text hello
body so at the moment I that I claim is
the entirety of a web page but it
currently lives in my code space so to
speak in a file called hello.html that's
fine if I want to create it but how do I
how do you how does anyone on the
internet actually view it well to serve
a web page you indeed need a web server
and it turns out that codespaces comes
with one of these pre-installed because
we cs50 staff uh did so for you and what
you can do in a terminal window once you
have an HTML file ready to go that you
want the world to see you can literally
run in your terminal window
http-server single command and what
that's going to do for you is start a
web server that is to say a program
whose purpose in life is just to serve
web pages and even though probably up
until now for years you probably if
you're like me equate server quote
unquote with a physical device server is
really aie piece of software it just
tends to run on big fancy devices so
when we say server we often all think of
in our Mind's Eye you know big expensive
devices perhaps but a server is just a
program whose purpose in life is to
respond to requests with responses and
that's the vernacular there now once you
run HTTP server and I'm going to do a
bit of magic because I set this up
before class just to make sure it goes
smoothly you'll see some output like
this whereby your server is now
available on a very long URL mine here
uh uh is a very long URL that will be
different from yours but what this is is
a unique identifier that your codes
space has temporarily generated so that
you can now access and ideally only you
can access that file using your browser
now if I flip the URL or you flip the
your all to public by right clicking or
control clicking the right features of
vs code you can enable anyone in the
world to visit it but we're not going to
ultimately host our websites in your
code space because as soon as you log
off for the night and the thing shuts
down like the website will go down but
at the end end of the semester
particularly for final projects we'll
show you ways that you can put your own
website your own code on the actual
internet
247365 even with your own domain name if
you want to get one so that it lives uh
independent of your own sleep schedule
and usage schedule of vs code here so
I'm going to go ahead now and visit um
this URL in another tab of my browser
and what I'll see here is this this is
the output of that program called HTTP
server and essentially what it is doing
is it's using TCP and IP in conjunction
with HTTP to just run your very own web
server on gith hubs own servers as well
and that's because of different ports
again we won't go too much into the
weeds of the TCP the IP and all of that
stuff but recall that different port
numbers can allow you to distinguish one
service from another now one of the
services is of course your code space
VSS code in the cloud that we've been
using for weeks but if you want to use
the same physical server that GitHub
controls but actually visit your own web
server that I just ran in my terminal
window in another tab that's fine
they're just going to be using different
TCP ports and you and I don't have to
care what they are but just that this is
a feature that TCP supports so what you
see here is somewhat Arcane this is not
like a thing that most people on the
internet should ever see I'm just doing
this for development purposes but this
is the index that is the directory the
the folder contents of my code space and
because I deleted everything from prior
weeks already all we see right now is
hello.html
which I just created so if I click on
hello.html within this folder listing
you'll be a little underwhelmed and I'll
zoom in just so there's something more
interesting there but now you see hello
comma body but what's interesting
perhaps is that after this long very
cryptic and uninteresting URL notice at
the very end of it and I'll zoom in in a
moment what do you see slh hello.html
which follows the convention I claimed
before break is how a browser would
allow you to to access a specific file
on a server by doing slash and then the
name of the file name everything before
it is very cryptic it would be better if
I you know uh buy a domain name that's a
little more easy to remember and set
that up some other time but for now
let's just focus on only the file names
that I'm actually creating all right so
the code is up and running underwhelming
though it might be with the body in the
middle of the page and let me zoom in up
here too hello comma title is indeed in
the tab just as promised so what's
actually going on with code like this
that we just created well let's go back
to the slide version of the same and let
me just highlight a few of these lines
the very first line is what's called
your document type declaration doesn't
really matter to remember that by
phrasing and this is just something you
copy paste or do from memory at the top
of any HTML file that you create when
making your own web page it's a implicit
indicator to the browser that you're
using the very latest version of HTML
which is version five you don't mention
the number five just browsers now
nowadays are program to look for this to
know that you're using the very latest
version of the language languages just
like human languages evolve over time
we're up to version five of HTML but new
features get added every few years so
indeed this lecture this class has been
evolving over time too so let's now
focus on the next line as well as the
bottom line and you'll notice some
deliberate symmetry here this here is
what we're going to call a tag and it's
technically different from this this is
a document type declaration it's got the
weird exclamation point that's the only
anomaly everything else follows pattern
this is a tag in HTML and it's the HTML
tag and a tag generally both starts and
stops or opens and closes at some point
so this is the so-called start tag or
open tag and this just means essentially
to the browser hey browser here comes
some HTML the language in which web
pages are written this here with the
forward slash after the angled bracket
means hey browser that's it for the HTML
of this page so that's what I mean by
symmetry I started a thought here
finished it down here what's in between
those two thoughts well here browser or
rather let me clarify one thing this
thing here is that other uh keyword an
attribute an attribute is something that
modifies the behavior of a tag so it's
similar to an argument in C or in Python
like a parameter to a function these
aren't functions but it's the same idea
it just modifies the default behavior of
something instead Lang equals you can
probably guess just means that hey
browser assume that everything Hereafter
is in English and that might be useful
for like Google translate or just search
engine optimization so that just the
server the browser know like what human
language you have actual content in like
hello title hello body even though a
good computer can probably infer from
Context often all right so that's an
attribute that's a tag and the whole
thing here everything in between the
start tag and end tag we would also call
an HTML element that just means
everything related to that open and
close tag all right now notice indented
inside of so to speak the HTML open and
close tag are another pair of tags the
head tag and the body tag or the head
element collectively and the body
element collectively and same idea hey
browser here comes the head of my page
hey browser that's it for the head hey
browser here comes the body of my page
hey browser that's it for the body the
head is essentially the tiny little
strip at the very top including the tab
itself the body is like 95% of
everything else the big rectangular
region what's inside of your title at
the at of your head of the web page at
the moment just the title so this
indicates hey browser Here Comes My
Title hey browser that's it for the
title the title of course is literally
quote unquote hello comma title
meanwhile if we bounce back out here is
the uh second element inside of the HTML
tag uh this says Hey browser here comes
the body hey browser that's it for the
body and hey browser this is the
contents these are the contents of the
body itself now the indentation is a
stylistic thing I did it just to be sort
of neat and en TIY because it suggests
what is inside of what but it also
suggests a sort of hierarchy and in fact
we'll use terminology from like the
world of family trees if this is like a
parent so to speak head and body would
be the child elements of the HTML tag
meanwhile title is a child of the head
tag or equivalently tital is a
grandchild of HTML so you can use the
same sort of vernacular as in the human
world when it comes to uh familial
relationships too and that just H set
again the same hierarchy so we have tags
and they include HTML head title body
and that's it for now we have attributes
we've seen one example of them Lang but
we'll see many other examples of the
same idea but these building blocks are
exactly the same generally you start a
thought you finish a thought and you
might do something in between questions
on this basic structure of any web
page any questions at
all no all right so let's now now allow
things to ramp up a little more
interestingly and do something with
these building blocks but so that you
have a mental model for everything
that's going on here on after think of
this same HTML being related in spirit
to week five when we talked all about
data structures if I really wanted to I
could take to heart this idea of
children and parents and grandparents
and really depict this thing graphically
and in fact this tree here if you will
and it's not a binary tree it's not a
binary search tree it's just a tree uh
used week five's terminology if this
special node here represents the whole
document well the root element as I
called it is HTML HTML has two children
head and body the head tag has in turn a
title uh child and in turn has some text
just as the body has some text and so
this is what your browser is doing you
and I the programmers write this stuff
the browser reads this code top to
bottom left to right whenever you visit
a website and inside of the computer's
memory Chrome Edge Firefox Safari what
what not they build this data structure
in the computer's memory so as to know
what it is you have told them to do and
we'll see over time at the end of today
you can write code in an actual
programming language JavaScript to maybe
dynamically add or remove things from
this tree and this is how things like
Gmail work when you open up your Gmail
inbox if you're a Gmail user if you just
stay there long enough you'll probably
get more and more mail and what happens
you don't have to like reload the page
or rebuild the tree per se it just all
of a sudden appears at the top
at the top at the top what's happening
there is that Google wrote some code
that just keeps adding more nodes to
this tree every time they realize you've
got a new message again and again so
that's the relationship now even with
this world of HTML with all of the
programmatic ideas we looked at in the
past all right so let's go ahead and do
something with this that's a little more
interesting than just hello itself I'm
going to go ahead and hide my terminal
window because the server is now running
and all I want to do now is experiment
with uh hello and other examples as well
let me go ahead and actually before I do
that let me go ahead and run uh code of
paragraphs. HTML just so I can keep my
code separate and now I'll hide the
terminal window again um paragraphs.
HTML I'm going to do almost exactly the
same let me go ahead and start with
something familiar and eventually I'll
start copying and pasting just to save
time so doc type HTML is always there
open the HTML tag and now notice I
didn't type the rest of that just like
with C just like with python we try to
save you some keystrokes by closing
parentheses adding quotes the HTML
support in VSS code is pretty good too
and it tries to finish your thought when
it comes to tags as well it can screw
things up if you if it does something
you don't want it to do so sometimes you
have to delete but it's just
autocomplete as we've seen before uh
let's go ahead and let me add Lang
equals as all of my examples today will
be let's add the head tag let's go and
proactively add the body tag and now
let's go ahead and give this a title tag
uh which has a I'll just call this
paragraphs just so I remember which
example is what now notice all of this
white space and all of this neat and
tidy indentation the browser ultimately
is not going to care about this is just
for us humans to kind of keep ourselves
saying when we look at the code it's
just easier to read but strictly
speaking I could minimally delete all of
this white space and I could just move
all of this tag up to the same line both
I think are fine I'll just going to
follow a certain convention but this too
would have the exact same meaning but
we'll see where that detail about whites
space could potentially get us into
trouble later in my paragraphs tag let's
do this in advance I've written up some
Latin like text a really long paragraph
of Latin like text like this it's
actually random nonsense it's not real
Latin even though a couple of the words
might look familiar and so here we have
three paragraphs of text and I've
deliberately hit enter in between them
so that just like an essay in Google
Docs or Microsoft Word hopefully I'll
see three separate paragraphs let me now
change tabs and I'll close hello.html
from before I'm going to go back to my
other tab here I'm going to click back
to go back to that index of all of my
files which I started at earlier and
you'll see now that I have two files
because I obviously just created a
second file called paragraphs. HTML so
let's click on this to see our three
paragraphs of Latin like text and voila
I'll zoom out all right first bug if you
will this just looks like one massive
blob of text not three Blobs of text and
why might that be borrowing the the hint
I offered a moment
ago why are we not seeing break yeah so
we need some kind of line breaks here
because the browser turns out is only
going to take us literally and if you
just give it text text text it's just
going to show you text and anytime
there's more than a single white space
whether it's two or 20 or 200 it's going
to just assume that you did that just to
be neat and tidy and it's going to
collapse them into just one space
visually like this so there are in fact
a couple of solutions one is this here I
could add some explicit line breaks and
it turns out that there's a br tag like
this and just for uh visibility sake let
me do two of them so like hitting enter
enter on my keyboard I'll do it here too
BR for break break and now let me go
back to my other tab nothing's changed
yet but that's because I have to reload
I've changed it on the server but now I
need to change it in the browser by
reloading and now it looks a little
better albeit nonsensical but you'll
know is a curiosity per this BR tag this
is kind of poorly designed it's a little
hackish to just say enter enter and make
the browser do this breaks line breaks
don't actually require Clos tags or end
tags so not all tags need to be closed
at least those that it just makes no
semantic sense to close them right like
the break is there or it's not you can't
imagine like starting to move to the
next line and then eventually getting
around to finishing like it's either
there or it's not so some tags do not
have closed tags as necessary but
there's a more elegant way here I dare
say not just sort of hackish putting in
these line breaks let me do this instead
I'll delete those and let me go ahead
and as the name of this file suggests
let me add a paragraph tag now here I
need to fight with vs codes autocomplete
because I don't want to finish the
sentence uh the thought there let me go
ahead and open the paragraph tag and
close a paragraph tag and just to keep
things tidy I'll go ahead and indent two
even though the indentation itself
doesn't matter let me go ahead and
create another tag for opening this
paragraph and I'll close this one here
and now let me see sometimes it's
fighting with my auto complete but
that's fine because I did this sort of
the wrong way at first and now let me go
ahead and finish this thought by closing
this paragraph tag here and I've
manually fixed all of my indentation so
now on line 10 I have the equivalent of
hey browser start a paragraph and then
it does the Latin like text then on line
12 hey browser that's it for this
paragraph and repeat repeat repeat if I
now go back to my other Tab and reload
again shouldn't be all that different
but semantically it's a little bit
better why because just saying break
break doesn't really mean anything but
by saying paragraph paragraph paragraph
now there's some more semantic
information there now if like Google is
analyzing your page or if the programmer
is trying to understand what it is you
did in the past when writing this code
you just know semantically oh this is a
paragraph This is a paragraph This is a
paragraph just like in a book or or an
essay so it's a little more clear
focusing more on what it is not how you
want to display it any questions then on
these
paragraphs now all right so a few more
tags and indeed these first few examples
will really just be like sort of bang
bang bang just a bunch of different
vocabulary words in the form of these
new tags but we won't go through the
entire laundry list of tags this is
indeed the thing for which web
references and books and the like are
ultimately helpful just like a
dictionary in the real world so I'm
going to go ahead and do this let me go
ahead and copy this let me create a new
file called headings. HTML just so we
have a new file for this to save time
I'm just going to paste that exact same
code just to get me started I'm going to
change the title of it for clarity for
the code online to headings and now just
like a book or an essay or a thesis let
me actually put some actual headings
here now if my first heading like
chapter one I could do something like
this up here I could have a paragraph
like I just learned and I could say
something like chapter one here but
that's not really a paragraph and so
it's sort of better designed to tell the
browser and really tell the world what
it is so it turns out there's another
tag I can use like H1 for heading and
like most important heading and in here
I'm just going to keep it simple and I'm
going to say something like one and in
fact this is so short here's a good
candidate for just keeping this all on
the same line but this has no functional
difference but it'll just make it a
little tur more tur on the screen now
let me go ahead down here and I could
have multiple headings so H1 2 and down
here I could have another one H1
three and if I go back to my other tab I
reload it now we should see just like a
book or an essay now we have some
proper now we have some oops I have to
go to the right file sorry if I go back
to the index now we see the new third
file called headings. HTML and now we
indeed see some fairly pretty if simple
headings as well now if these aren't
three chapters 1 two three but maybe
it's a chapter then a section then a
subsection such that just visually you
want things to get smaller and smaller
well those exist too and in fact you can
do H1 through H6 H1 a little
paradoxically is the biggest and boldest
H6 is the smallest but still bold so it
might make sense to make this H2 both
open and close and maybe this H3 open
and close if again this is a section or
a subsection inside of that chapter if I
reload now notice just gets a little
smaller so it's more similar to what
you'd see on the printed page but this
now is just another three tags that I
might use in my own code all right well
how about lists of things I have three
paragraphs here but let's do this let me
go back to vs code I'm going to copy
this code so I have a starting point I'm
going to create a new file called say
list. HTML here I'm going to copy paste
I'm going to change my title to be list
just for clarity and in here I'm going
to go ahead and get rid of this whole
body because let's move away from these
massive paragraphs and keep it simpler
for now if I want to have a list of
things uh for instance uh if you haven't
seen these already a computer scientist
when they're fishing for just some
arbitrary meaningless words uh they
often use Foo bar and baz just as their
go-to just like a mathematician might
use XY Z for variables so Fu bar and baz
are on three separate lines and maybe
this is like my to-do list or my
shopping list but you can probably
imagine if I go back to my other tab go
back to the index I now see my new file
list.
HTML but it's probably going to look
wrong I think I'm just going to say yeah
Fubar baz all in one breath if you will
the not on new line and you can try to
fight this like you can be like really
want to put some line breaks there go
back and reload it's still not going to
make any change how do I want to fix
this well I can do this in a few ways I
could make them paragraphs but they're
not really paragraphs they're a list so
I'm going to use a different tag instead
I'm going to create for instance an
unordered list using the UL tag open and
close inside of that I'm going to use
the list item tag Li I and I'm going to
say Foo inside of another tag I'm going
to say bar inside of a third tag open
and close I'm going to say baz so it's
getting a little verbose but it's still
relatively succinct Li is all you need
type for list item UL is all you need
type for unordered list so there's some
shorthand syntax here that's adopted if
I now reload you're going to see a
so-called unordered list like not sorted
which means by convention to show it as
bullets though it could be displayed in
different ways visually as well if you
actually change your mind and you
realize oh I'd really like to number
this well you could obviously like just
add one and two and three but that's
going to get annoying especially if the
list grows you want to change something
insert something in the middle then you
have to reorder it I mean we using
computers here they can do this for us
so we can change the UL to any
guesses o maybe for ordered list which
is sort of the opposite here so let's
try changing that to O let me go back to
my browser and I'm just hitting command
r or controlr to reload the page instead
of clicking the button every time now I
automatically get 1 2 and three and you
can even override the Aesthetics using
different numera bles or symbology
instead but that would be perhaps the
most common there as well all right it's
a lot of tags quickly but any questions
on lists paragraphs headings or the like
no all right so let me go ahead and
propose this here um let's go ahead and
create what we'll call a table so let me
copy and paste this into a new file code
of table. HTML and in table. HTML let me
again rename the title to table let me
get rid of that ordered list from before
and let me now use a table tag open and
close this one's a little weird but
inside of a table you typically have a
head of the table so uh I'll say well
let's say the first row we'll keep this
one simple a table row or TR inside of a
table row you would ideally have columns
but that's not the nomenclature instead
you have data so TD for table data and
let me go ahead and just have the first
datm be one I'm just going to
arbitrarily do 1 two three just so we
have something to play with and you know
what just for demonstration sake I am
going to deliberately copy paste this
twice and I'm just going to manually
change the numbers just so we can see
what I'm creating 789 and then maybe
just for good measure if you're seeing
where this is going let me copy this one
more time and give myself a final row
with an asterisk a zero and a pound sign
if maybe you see where this is going let
me go back to my other tab let me go
back to the index there's my new file
table. HTML I'll click that and while
it's not very pretty I'll zoom in it's
indeed a table of data I happen to mimic
like a key uh a telephone keypad but you
could imagine this being much juicier
much more interesting scientific or
financial data or the like laid out into
these rows TRS and these columns AKA
table data as well so we have that
ability as well for structured data now
of course the internet um has lots of
images on it and in fact this is all
just text how can we introduce images
well let me go ahead and do this let me
first uh sort of semi secretly copy an
image file that I brought from uh
earlier just so we have something to
play with and I have in my account here
now an image called harbor. JPEG and I
uploaded this semi- secretly a second
ago into my account so that I can
reference a second file let me go ahead
and copy this HTML just to save myself
some keystrokes
let me go ahead and do code of image.
HTML and let me paste that code and hide
my terminal window I'm going to get rid
of all of this table as just
uninteresting now we're going to make
this even simpler by changing my title
to image to keep all these
demonstrations uh separate and now if I
want to make a web page that when
visited shows us a picture of Harvard
well there's an image tag abbreviated
IMG for short I can specify what the
source of that image is and if my file a
JPEG in this case is literally in the
same folder I can just say quote unquote
harvard. jpeg if it's in a folder I
should mention the folder name in a
slash or something like that if the
image is on the internet somewhere with
a URL I could also have a whole URL
https colon and then the URL of the
image but I upload it in in advance now
this is just going to visually display
on the screen but not everyone of course
can see images screen readers might need
a bit of assistance and even search
engines might want to analyze the page
and know what this is an image of now
machine learning and artificial
intelligence are maybe getting better to
be fair at figuring out just by
analyzing images what they are but
they're certainly imperfect I am a human
I know pretty well what I took a photo
of for instance so maybe what I should
do proactively which would be good for
accessibility is have this alt tag for
alternative text and then literally say
like Harvard University so that someone
who can't see or so that a a server can
actually know with higher probability
what it is uh they're looking at and I
could be even more detailed than just a
phrase I could describe the image as
well all right let me go back to my
index in the second tab let me go back
and zoom back out there's my new file
and there's my new JPEG that I quickly
uploaded before I can click now on
image. HTML and albeit a little
overwhelming that is a really big image
of harvor now apparently it's too big to
fit on the screen so this isn't the best
user experience to have to scroll up
okay so there's the image horrible
horrible design if you will at least in
terms of my code but there's going to be
ways where I can sort of rein that in
and affect the height or the width as
well but for now it's just deliberately
a little overwhelming instead now we can
do something a little more fun and
topical today uh which might be to use
an IM a video instead so let me go ahead
here and very quickly grab another file
today which is uh I brought in advance
and that you might have seen briefly
earlier which is an MP4 an actual video
file and what I'm going to do here by
revealing vs code again is I'm going to
code a file called video. HTML get
another demonstration here I'm going to
change my title to video just to keep
these things straight and instead of the
image tag you might imagine using now
indeed a video tag and this is a
relatively newer tag that has increasing
support among browsers so it's good now
to use and inside of this the syntax is
a little different you specify and this
is weirdly annoyingly in consistent not
SRC for Source you literally say source
and then in Source you use a source
attribute horrible design semantically
but like this is what we're stuck with
halloween. MP4 is the name of the video
we uploaded in advance made by some of
harder Harvard's digital artists and the
type of this video so that the browser
knows for sure is video/ MP4 that's a
so-called content type that you just
know or you look up to figure it out and
just so that this is as animated as
possible I'm going to tell the video tag
with a few attributes to autoplay and it
turns out that attributes often have key
value pairs whereby it's the key the
attribute name equals quote unquote some
value just like Lang equals quote
unquote for English but not all
attributes need values in fact if you
read the documentation for html's video
tag there's an autoplay attribute where
you can literally just say the key and
it needs no value it's just going to
mean autoplay and if you don't want to
autoplay you just omit it alt together
so so you don't necessarily need a value
on or off uh I want the thing to Loop
just so it keeps going I want it to be
muted so that we don't hear any sound in
fact there is no sound but browsers
nowadays for anti-spam and advertising
reasons often will not play a video if
it has sound because it's just kind of
obnoxious if you visit a page and all of
a sudden your speakers start blaring so
I know this from having read up on this
that I should mute it so if I want it to
actually autoplay for real and then I'll
set the width manually for now to be
like 128 pixels across just from some
trial and error earlier and that with
attribute does have a value now I'm
being a little um a little uptight here
by alphabetizing all of my attributes
not at all necessary I do it just so I
can skim things faster and know if
something is there or not so for me it's
just a matter of style let me go back to
my other tab go back to my index and
you'll see two new files again the mp4
file and video. HTML I'll click on the
ladder and if I did this well here we
have thank thanks to our friends in
Harvard U our artistic friends at
Harvard very like an oo would help with
the drama here but okay but we have a
very dramatic nice Halloween type view
here as well so we have videos embedded
as well and suffice it to say there's
ways to embed YouTube videos or Vimeo or
other services as well using yet more
tags too but the web is of course all
about hyperlink Hyper text markup
language where you click on something
and you end up somewhere else and this
is how the web is so powerfully
interconnected
so how do we start creating links from
one website or web page to another
either that I made or someone else well
let me go ahead and open back up my
terminal window and let's create a file
called link. HTML just to demonstrate
what you and I know as a link I'll hide
my terminal window now let me copy paste
just to save myself some keystrokes and
let me get rid of the video tag so we
can focus now on links suppose that I
want you to visit Harvard virtually well
I could say something like visit uh
Harvard period this is uninteresting
because it's just going to be text I
probably want you to actually visit
harvard.edu instead more specifically
and I'll lower case it just to be
consistent with what browsers do in the
address bar all right let me go now to
the video uh back to this video Tab and
go back where we now see my index I'll
Zoom back in and there's link. HTML
unfortunately when I click this and I'll
zoom in you literally just see the text
that I wrote and yet on every social
media platform nowadays except like
Instagram when you type a URL or what
looks like a URL even if you didn't
bother with the HTTP or https it usually
automatically links it for you on
Facebook on Twitter and other sites as
well that's just a convenience Discord
and slack do that too but they're just
doing it to make things more
userfriendly but they have to generate
HTML with the proper tags and attributes
so to get this to actually work it's not
even good enough to say
https www.harvard.edu because if I go
back now and reload now you'll literally
just see all of that as text if you want
the browser to treat this as a link you
need to use the anchor tag it'd be great
if it were called the link tag but it's
not it's called The Anchor tag or a for
short and the way you reference the URL
to which you want to lead the user is
via href for hyper reference this is one
of the earliest tags perhaps among the
most Arcane now but if I then put that
whole URL in quotes and close my tag I
now have to opportunity to finish my
thought in between the start tag and the
end tag for this anchor and what I put
in between the start and end tag is
whatever the human's going to see so
here I can say Harvard I can go back to
my other tab I can reload the page and
now you see the familiar blue underline
this now is an actual link and if I
click it I'll be whisked away to the
actual Harvard websites but there's a
risk here can anyone imagine pretty
simply after like what 60 seconds of the
link tag of the anchor tag how could
someone an adversary misuse this tag
alone How could a website run by an
adversary How could a spammer misuse
this tag do you think
yeah yeah absolutely you could have it
say one thing but lead another lead
elsewhere so I could say Yale in here
nothing stopping me as the developer go
back to the page reload now it says
visit Yale you click on Yale and voila
you end up applying to the wrong place
instead now there's some hints of this I
could hover over this and super small
like this isn't very good for your
anti-hacking techniques but way down
here you can actually see the URL that
it's going to go to in most browsers
indeed do this at least on desktops and
laptops so it's a little bit of a hint
but what you're seeing here even though
this is kind of a silly um uh playful
example this is exactly how fishing
attacks work p i sh iing work whereby an
adversary tells you to log into your
PayPal account but it doesn't go to
paypal.com it goes to some other random
website that they bought and built that
then tries to collect your username and
password and stored in their database so
now they can log into your PayPal
account as you and it boils down to that
simple primitive and you can be even
more manipulative to you can even say
the whole URL for Yale like yale.edu or
Worse htps www.yale.edu reload that and
now who I mean who among you and people
in your lives are necessarily going to
be so paranoid as to not just blindly
click on that URL this is why just being
a defensive real world person nowadays
digitally is just ever more so important
so these same things that can be used
for good or uh benign use cases can also
be used for ill purposes too and it is
literally that simple questions now on
any of these tags thus
far just a few more to offer up any
questions on this
here no well let me open up a couple
that I brought in advance just so we
don't have to type all of them here um
if you for instance have a web page
that's got quite a bit of code let me go
ahead and grab from the website a couple
of examples real fast here namely one
that we'll call how about uh meta
HTML and in this example here give me
just a moment to full screen it we're
going to
have a file So codem Meta HTML I'll open
this up next no relationship to what we
now know as meta the company but rather
this is going to be a page that I copied
and pasted the same chunk of Latin like
text from earlier so it's going to be a
really big paragraph of text and this is
an example where if you were to open
this web page not on my own Mac or your
PC but on your phone the font might
actually be really annoying and
difficult to read why because your
phone's going to try to squeeze all of
the content onto the tiny viewport the
rectangular region of your phone instead
so it turns out there are ways pretty
easy ways to make your website mobile
friendly as well Otherwise Known
technically as responsive and the
easiest way to do this is to include
this tag here a meta tag again no
relationship to Facebook this has been
here much longer and this case here this
meta tag online five has its own sort of
approach to key value pairs this is a
good example of where it'd be nice if it
looked just like everything else but
this is what we have historically
you can have a meta tag with an
attribute called name that refers to the
name of some feature of the browser in
this case viewport is the technical term
for like the big rectangular region to
which I keep referring the body really
of your page the content for the
viewport you can say some AR esoteric
details like this the initial scale
should be one that is no matter who
visits your site it shouldn't start
zoomed in it shouldn't start zoomed out
it should start at just the default
sizing and then this here with equals
device width is a very arcane way of
saying if the user has a small screen
show the text proportional to that size
don't just try to cram it all into a
tiny little window so it's super simple
but if for the next problem set or
future projects as well you find that
just things look really bad on mobile
like this kind of tag is the place to
start meta there aren't terribly many of
these that you'll use but they're useful
for other mechanisms as well in fact let
me go ahead and semi secretly pull up
one other example as well whereby I'm
going to grab another example that uses
more of these tags and in just a moment
I'll reveal it here give me just one
second here I'll have I'll propose that
in this
example of
meta we now add these properties instead
so I copy pasted this from an existing
file just so as to not waste time typing
all of these out if you've ever shared a
URL on Facebook or Twitter or slack or
Discord order any number of websites
nowadays that automatically show a nice
preview where you sudden instantly see
like the default image of the page maybe
a few sentences or words of text or
something like that sometimes those
applications those websites will just
choose like the first image it finds on
the website or the first sentence it
sees and show that but that might not be
very user friendly or search engine
friendly and so a prog a developer might
want to control what it is that slack
Discord Facebook Twitter and other such
sites show by default for that can use
nowadays what are called open graph tags
which is to say there's other uses of
the meta tag and you just look these
things up even I had to look this up to
remember what the key value pairs are
the meta tag can also have a property
attribute that can be these very
specific strings OG title OG description
OG image which denotes open graph which
again is this standard that's evolved in
recent years and what you can do here is
tell browsers and in turn servers what
you want them to show as the default
title of the page P the description of
the page and even the default image just
so you can exercise more control when
sharing things socially nowadays as well
again it just boils down to these key
value pairs this is absolutely the kind
of thing you look up as needed to cross
check but those capabilities are there
and so literally the next time you paste
a link into slack or Discord or any
online site that then displays it in
embedded fashion just know that all this
time a little bit of textual code like
this in HTML has been there by whoever
authored the site
all right let's do one final example in
HTML alone before we transition to just
cleaning up the Aesthetics and improving
the visuals of everything we've been
creating let me go ahead here and close
meta HTML let me code up a new file
called how about search. HTML and see if
we can't draw some inspiration from our
cursory understanding earlier of how
URLs work to see if we can't reinvent
google.com itself so recall that a
canonical URL might look like this here
and in particular if you want to pass in
user input to that URL again you can
potentially have a question mark and
then a key equals value pair or for that
matter you can even have multiple key
value pairs that by convention are
separated by ampers sense these things
are everywhere like later today when you
pull up almost any website in your
browser look at the URL and you'll just
see a lot of this a lot of noise too and
distractions but there's going to be
some equal signs most likely Andor some
ampersands as well and those are just
separating key value pairs now what can
I do here well if you think back to how
we manually searched for cats earlier
let me quickly do this I'll do this one
manually doc type HTML as my very first
line HTML tag with how about my Lang
attribute for English up here and then
inside of this I'll have a head tag
inside of this I'll have a title I'll
call this example uh search and then
down here I'll have my beginning of a
body tag and now let me introduce you to
really a final tag for now uh a form tag
which will create a web form the thing
with text boxes and buttons that you and
I use every day on any number of
websites inside of this form I'm going
to have an input like a text box whose
name is going to be Q for query because
I'm trying to re-implement Google here
uh the uh type of that I want to be a
text box or if I know I'm using this for
search I can actually change this to a
search box and it's going to let me it's
going to generally put a little X there
so you can clear it quickly that's a
nice little enhancement as well and then
I'm going to give myself a submit button
by doing input whoops I'm going to give
myself a submit button by doing input
type equals submit and then I'll leave
that as such here all right now I need
to do a little bit more but let's see
how this looks let me go over to my
other tab let me go back to my index and
if I zoom
out there is search. HTML I'll click it
and there's not much going on here even
if I zoom in but I do indeed have a
really big text box and a submit button
but I haven't in my HTML told anyone
anywhere that I want this input whether
I type cat or dog to go to google.com so
for that I need a couple of more
attributes and I know this from having
done this before and any online
reference will say the same you can add
an action attribute like what do you
want the action of this form to be and
you can put the URL to which you want
this form to be submitted and I know
from tinkering that it should be hdps
www.google.com search I don't need to
put any question marks here myself but I
do want the uh browser to do that for me
so let me go back to my other tab let me
reload and nothing visually has happened
but watch this when I now type in cats
but before I hit enter notice that I'm
currently at some long crazy URL search.
HTML is expected if I now go down to the
submit button and click submit watch
what happens to the URL and the page
itself I'm whisked away to the actual
google.com and indeed there are those
same cats and if I zoom in here you'll
see that my URL has changed to be indeed
SL search question mark Q equals cats so
this is just how web forms work when you
submit any form on the web in this way
the browser automatically goes to that
action URL adds a question mark puts any
key value pairs that you manually typed
into the text boxes and lets the server
do its thing now here's where Chrome is
starting to simplify things Safari does
this too if you double click on your url
now you see the full URL but if any
parts are missing that's just a UI thing
to eliminate visual distractions
nowadays meanwhile if I go back to my
own form if I search this time for dogs
and hit enter now again the URL changes
to be Q equals dogs and it all reduces
to this basic building block of using an
a form tag now I can be more explicit if
I know I want to use get it which is
actually the default I can literally say
quote unquote get in all lowercase even
though the verb earlier was by Design in
uppercase but here now I'm just being
ever more explicit if I don't want the
label of this button to be very
generically submit maybe I want it to be
Google search quote unquote well if you
read the documentation for forms you can
actually change the value of the button
to be quote unquote Google search and if
I now go back here and reload I get a
fresh form and now I get a button that
literally says Google Search and if I
tinker with this further because this
isn't very user friendly there's even
more attributes I can do I can add on my
t uh search input a uh autoc complete
equals uh off if I don't want to see my
own history for whatever reason I don't
want people knowing I'm searching for
cats and dogs on this page I can
autofocus on the text box so that it
shows the cursor blinking in that box by
default and I can even do something like
this I can have a placeholder attribute
that says something like query or some
other documentation for the user and if
I now go back and reload you'll see
notice it says query and it's subtle but
my cursor is already positioned there it
gave it focus and I can type cats now
without having to click in the Box
manually which is just marginally better
for the user's experience any questions
now on all of this
here any
questions all right that too was a lot
why don't we take a casual five minute
break and when we resume we'll take a
look at CSS add in some JavaScript and
then wrap up so 5 minutes only for now
all right we are back so that's
technically it for HTML like here on out
it'll be up to like online resources and
references we point you to just to fill
in your vocabulary for more tags and
attributes but like conceptually that's
it there's attributes uh there are tags
and there are attributes and the rest of
it really is just kind of a laundry list
of capable uh possible features but it
turns out too you'll see over time that
you can even see the HTML for websit so
for instance if I go over to harvard.edu
in my browser which I'll go ahead in
just a moment here here and do here and
do
https
www.harvard.edu
enter it again will pull up today's
version of Harvard's website and if I
rightclick or control click on it again
and go to inspect you'll see those
so-called developer tools and earlier we
focused on the network tab just so we
could see the HTTP stuff going on but
what I glossed over earlier was the
so-called elements tab which actually
shows you the HTML underlying any web
page on the internet and so for instance
here is the underlying HTML for
Harvard's homepage as of right now and
aesthetically some of it's been
collapsed so if I click on these various
triangles I'll see what's actually
inside of that is the children of some
of these HTML tags but here on out if
you're ever curious as to like how a web
page uh made some feature visually you
can just literally use these developer
tools built into your own browser just
to see what the uh web developer
actually did and you can do things too
like this like if you really like maybe
uh let's see if you really like this
menu in the top right hand corner of
Harvard's website you can even
rightclick that or control click that
specifically choose inspect and what
browsers will do is jump to the HTML
corresponding to that visual element on
the page and here you can see though
we've not talked about this tag before
there's a button tag there's an ID
attribute and there's some other
attributes as well that Define that
button um you can do other things too in
the web page let me scroll down for
instance here and let's go actually
let's go to another one like yale.edu
here in today's theme and suppose we
want to do something like uh change the
Aesthetics of this website well let's do
how about this over here life at Yale
let's rightclick on this choose inspect
that's going to jump to that part of the
page and notice what you can do here in
this elements tab we can be a little a
little playful in return today life at
Harvard and voila we've now changed
Yale's website it would seem so have we
really like hopefully hacking is not
actually this
easy what did we actually do based on
today's mental
model like I have changed the page
but yeah just changed how it is for me
right because my browser just like with
Phyllis and Brian from the GetGo
requested Yale's web page I got back a
virtual envelope containing that HTML as
we've now called it my browser has a
local copy it's got its own tree
otherwise known as a Dom document object
model built up in its memory and yeah I
went to town and changed my copy of it
but of course hopefully I've not changed
the actual server and in fact if I
reload Yale's website now hopefully it
will revert back to indeed yep what it
should be instead life at Yale but this
ability in your own browser be it Chrome
or Firefox or Edge or Safari to have
these built-in developer tools are very
powerful because it's going to enable
you to not only diagnose problems that
will invariably arise in the coming
weeks with your own code but is also
going to allow you to learn from other
sites like how you can do things and
Tinker as well but up until now we
focused only on tags and attributes and
on the structure of a web page let's now
focus more on the Aesthetics and
fine-tuning that it turns out that HTML
has very limited support for anything
aesthetic like font sizes and colors and
so forth and in recent years people have
used necessarily a second language
called CSS not a programming language
again a markup language if you will to
just fine-tune the Aesthetics of a page
font sizes colors margins and all of
that so CSS is going to allow us to
define a whole bunch of properties which
is just another group of people's
terminology for key value pairs indeed
ever since week five like key value
pairs are everywhere in the world not
just at like sweet green and restaurants
but indeed under in line code and
languages and Technologies like these so
properties is the new word in CSS for
what a moment ago we called attributes
in H but it's the same idea just
different vocabulary that you get used
to over time a few phrases I might use
now and you'll hear in the coming days
would be these type selector class
selector ID selector attribute selector
which just refer to different techniques
we're about to see that are going to
allow you to control more precisely the
Aesthetics of specific things on the
page and the way we're going to do this
is we're going to take our basic HTML
like we saw earlier and we're going to
introduce in the next few minutes just a
couple of more tags and or attributes
one we're going to introduce you to a
tag called style which nicely named
allows you to um allows you to control
the style the Aesthetics the visuals of
the web page or we're going to introduce
you to a link tag which very confusingly
does not give you a link that you can
click on it just links to another file
that then gets automatically included or
imported to borrow our language from C
or in Python but same idea this will
allow us to include secondary files and
we're going to ultimately show you how
you can leverage third third party
Frameworks libraries that other people
wrote so as to not get stuck in the
weeds of all the fine tuning of
Aesthetics and just make pretty things
fast so you can focus really on the
intellectually interesting part if
that's your choice of building the
content the site out the application out
yourself all right so with that said let
me go back to vs code here and let me go
ahead and create a simple example called
home.html like a very simple homepage
for John Harvard for instance let me
give myself three paragraphs initially
the first of which is just going to have
uh the person name the second paragraph
is going to say something like welcome
to my
homepage uh to greet visitors and the
third is going to be like a little
footer like copyright uh how about John
Harvard 1636 or something like that all
right let me go back to my other tab as
before reload my index there's my new
file home.html and I'll click that and
you'll see okay I mean this is sort of
1636 style web page super simple all
text nothing really interesting going on
there
but we can start to style it a little
differently like if the title of the
page is John Harvard and then it's
welcome to my homepage and then this
less important footer why don't we have
the text be large then medium then small
so something arbitrary but a little more
nuanced so let me go back to vs code
here and in my home.html file let me
introduce not yet the style tag but what
I'm going to call temporarily the style
attribute both indeed exist this one's
simpler and it's going to be correct but
we'll see in a moment not as well
designed arguably as is often our
narrative so inside of the style tag you
can put this language called CSS key
value pairs otherwise known as
properties the only way you know what
properties exist what keys exist is by
taking a class reading a book looking at
an online reference and we're going to
give you just a sampling of what's out
there so suppose I want to control the
font size of this first paragraph I can
literally say font Das size in all lower
case colon and then a word like large or
I can specify 12p point or 18 point or
something more precise like that like
from Google Docs or Microsoft Word and
suppose I want to make this text down
here uh medium well uh I'll do quote
unquote font size colon medium and down
here I'll do style equals uh font Das
size small so I'm going to start with
just these three key value pairs same
key but different values I'll go back to
my page and in a moment I'll reload and
it's going to be somewhat subtle but
watch how the font size do change when I
reload now all right so got a little
bigger middle one's about the same and
the last one is a little smaller what if
I want to center it just like many web
pages have the text like this centered
well I can separate these key value
pairs with semicolons and I'm sorry
semicolons are kind of sort of back with
CSS but I can do text-align Colon Center
strictly speaking I don't need the last
semicolon if there's no more key value
pairs but I'll just do it to be
consistent uh text align Colon Center
and then down here after another
semicolon text align Colon Center all
right let's go back reload now it's
going to be much more obvious the change
and we now have the beginnings of a
homepage still pretty basic but at least
it's a little more interesting turns out
we can do a little better with the
copyright symbol like most computers
actually have support for a circle with
a c in it but you can't just do that
with uh text like this there's different
ways to do this you could copy paste it
from like a website that already has it
so you don't have to figure out the mag
iCal keystroke on your Mac or PC but
there's also in HTML what are called
entities and you can actually specify
using heximal or decimal codes numbers
like this H1 169 semicolon after an
Amper sand and this is a special symbol
that you can look up in any online
reference for like special characters
that are hard or impossible to type
manually at your keyboard and this let
me zoom in just so it's obvious if I
reload now instead of being two
parentheses and a c character
now it's a proper Copyright symbol so
you'll see these out there they're not
necessarily that frequently used
nowadays but it's good to know that they
exist but let me go back now to my code
and propose that while correct uh this
is arguably not very welld designed and
even if you've never seen HTML never
seen CSS before what Instinct might you
have for why this is poorly
designed
yeah there's repetition right in general
in the past several weeks see python SQL
like repetition generally bad and and
sloppy and it's not going to scale well
so the repetition I think you're
probably alluding to is textalign Center
textalign Center textalign Center well
we can factor that out in CSS the C in
CSS means cascading and this means that
if you move some properties to like a
parent or a grandparent uh the children
or grandchildren will inherit those
properties that is they will Cascade
down the family tree so to speak and so
so let me go ahead and remove all of
these since I claim they're indeed
redundant and let me preserve just one
of them by well let me do this it's not
quite right to put a a paragraph inside
of a paragraph like that's just not a
thing in English writing or in writing
more generally so I'm going to do one
thing first it turns out that these two
are arguably not paragraphs right this
is like a header the body the essence of
the page and then the footer so if a
paragraph isn't quite the right English
semantics you can actually use more
generically a tag that's all over the
internet called div for division of the
page and this is just a very generic
term for like a big rectangular region
that divides the page again and again
just so that you can think about
different regions now that I have div
which really has no more meaning than
that it's a division of the page
interpret as you will now I can have
multiple ones of these and let me go
ahead and open a div tag here let me
close a new div tag here and then just
to keep everything tidy I'm going to
highlight everything in between and hit
Tab and that just automatically indents
everything for me now I have a three
divs inside of another div and that's
totally fine this is very commonly done
now I'm going to do this style equals
quote unquote text align Colon Center
semicolon or not and now I have some
cascading capabilities now the parent of
those three children John Harvard welome
to my homepage and the copyright will
now all inherit that property so when I
hit reload nothing aesthetically has
changed whoops sorry
um I should have done reload slightly
earlier when you use a div instead of a
paragraph it actually gets rid of the
par uh the space between those
paragraphs it just sandwiches them a
little closer together I can fix this in
another way but that aside everything is
still centered and the text is still
large medium and small but I should have
called out that change in the paragraph
spacing but we could bring that back
before long if we wanted now what more
could I do to maybe improve this well
strictly speaking I don't really need
that parent div right because these
three divs inside already had a parent
so let me actually get rid of that new
div just undo what I did I'll highlight
this and if you haven't seen this trick
shift tab will unindent nicely which is
perhaps helpful I could just put that
text align Center on the body tag so
text align Colon Center quote unquote
this two would work as well so long as
you go up the family tree so to speak
reload and now indeed there's nothing
aesthetically that has changed this time
but it turns out nowadays the web is
getting a little more sophisticated and
even though you will see so many
examples online and tutorials and books
using div div div div all over the place
there are newer semantic tags semantic
just means they have more meaning than
this generic notion of a division and if
you look up the a documentation for HTML
you'll see that if you want to have a
header on a page not a heading like H1
H2 but a header there's literally
nowadays a header tag and this is
marginally better because it now says
what it is search engines like Google
and Bing can detect oh that's the header
of the page maybe we should use this and
give it more prominence in the search
results you can then have a main part of
the page so literally a tag called main
nowadays you can literally have a footer
of the page and again these are often
useful for screen readers to help recite
things verbally for folks who might
otherwise not be able to read them and
probably these screen readers might
highlight the header and the main part
but maybe not might not spend time for
the user on the footer which is arguably
a little less important semantically
usually um or search engines again now
know what's the header what's the footer
what's the main part of the page so they
know what to search and analyze so this
would arguably be a a better design
nowadays as
well but what else remains as a problem
well this is now getting a little bit
more subtle and takes some experience
but this practice of putting HTML and
CSS all in the same file it's a little
sloppy why because it means I'm
co-mingling my data with the
presentation thereof like the juicy
stuff I care about like John Harvard and
the phrase welcome to my homepage and
all of the Aesthetics that I might want
to change over time and honestly because
everything is currently in one big file
it's going to make it really hard for me
to collaborate with a classmate or a
colleague at work so that maybe I do the
HTML they do the CSS like uhuh not if
you're all working in the same file it
would be a nightmare even if you use vs
code sharing feature like Google Docs
and both are typing at the same time
like you're going to mess up somehow
it'd be nice if we could separate these
two languages well one way to do that
would be as follows let me get rid of
all of the style tags sorry style
attributes that I've added up until
now on all four now of these tags and
let me introduce the style tag that we
saw on the slide earlier instead I'm
going to go up here into the head of the
page which is where technically these
style tags must go so that they're
already loaded into memory before the
body is even analyzed by the browser and
inside of the the style tag I'm actually
going to select the HTML elements that I
want to stylize if you will so if I want
to change the body's Aesthetics I'm
going to literally type the name of that
tag body and then I'm sorry curly braces
are back also from c u inside of these
curly braces I'm going to put text align
Center so the key value pairs are the
same the only new thing I've done is
I've moved some of the syntax up to this
new style tag in the head if I want to
now control the header tag as well I can
use the same curly braces this is
convention to put the open curly brace
on the same line the closed curly brace
on another the browser doesn't really
care but this is a common CSS style
convention I'm going to do font size
large semicolon then for the main tag
I'm going to do font size medium and
then for the footer tag I'm going to do
font size small so same exact thing and
it's admittedly a little bit more
verbose it's taking up more lines of
code it doesn't all quite fit on the
screen but if you scroll back down now
and you'll acquire an eye for this this
is just better like it's just more
compact it's more readable the the
content the data jumps out and there's
no visual distractions like the CSS
properties as before upside here too is
that we don't actually need to uh this
doesn't actually change the Aesthetics
if I reload the same page it still looks
the same but I've taken a step toward
some slightly better design but let me
propose that there's other ways to do
this too we just selected things by way
of their uh type so that was a so-called
type selector when I literally just
specifi the type of tag body header main
footer but there's other ways that now
we can lay the foundation for making
reusable CSS that you and colleagues and
classmates can use and reuse in multiple
files and even in multiple projects so
let me actually go ahead and do this
instead of just very explicitly saying I
want the body to be centered let me
invent an adjective if you will and let
me change this to do centered and this
new uh this new vocabulary word centered
will literally mean texal Center let me
go ahead here and I'm just going to
create a new adjective called large a
new adjective called medium and a new
adjective called small they are
deliberately consistent with what the
properties do but these are now my own
vocabulary words and they are called
classes so a class is just a collection
of key value
a collection of properties that you get
to invent for yourself and what it lets
you do now is this now if I want the
whole body to be centered I can add this
tag which we actually saw briefly in
Yale's HTML class equals centered down
here in the header if I want this to be
large I can say class equals quote
unquote large down here on Main I can
say class equals quote unquote medium
and down here I can have class equals
quote unquote small now I have taken one
step backward by read addding some of
the Aesthetics to the page but it's not
the actual properties it's not the key
value pairs it's now more semantically
nice because now I just know from
reading the HTML what these things are
going to look like whereas the
implementation details for all four of
those adjectives is now relegated up
above and these are literally my words I
could change it to Fu and use class
equals quote unquote Foo but obviously
that would not be the best choice of
words in this case all right any
questions on this this now is what we
would call a class selector by using
literally the dot even though the dot
does not appear elsewhere but dot means
this is a
class these are not always the best
syntactic design decisions that the
world makes all right well one last
trick then notice that this is a little
Annoying that I'm still working in the
same file and if my classmate wants to
clean up my Aesthetics make my homepage
look way better if my colleague wants to
do the same wouldn't it be nice if we
could actually move all of this code to
a different function file like a python
library or a c header file well you can
let me go ahead and delete that whole
style tag let me add a confusingly named
link tag the href of which let's call a
new file styles.css and let's say that
the relationship of that file is that of
stylesheet so this is a term of Art in
the world of web development a
stylesheet is a text file that contains
lots of styles lots of CSS properties
let me open my terminal real fast
and let me do code of
styles.css
enter and in this file I'm going to
paste all of those same lines as earlier
but now they're in a separate file and
indeed if I hide my terminal window and
I give this file to a colleague they can
now work on the Aesthetics of the page
and make things a lot prettier than this
maybe use specific font sizes maybe add
colors and the like whereas I can focus
entirely on the HTML because this file
now will reference that other and if I
go back to my other Tab and reload Cod
the content's going to be exactly the
same but now I'm using some separate
file
instead any questions now about these
techniques
here no all right so with that said let
me show just one example now of what I
called a moment ago Frameworks and this
is where web development gets kind of
fun at least if you like this especially
if you like the sort of logical design
the presentation of information you care
about but you really don't want to
struggle with like font sizes and colors
and getting everything Pixel Perfect so
to speak let me propose that I open up
here an example in just a moment in vs
code that I prepared in advance and this
one is going to be an opportunity to
consider how you might take some of the
data from last week which we had wherein
we collected everyone's favorites and
lay it out in a really big HTML table so
I wrote this out in advance because it
was a huge amount of data but it's the
same data from the Google form from last
week and you'll see already the hints of
a table tag and these TRS and I added a
few other tags for Aesthetics it turns
out when you have a more visually
interesting header for your table
there's another tag called T head
there's another tag called T body these
are not all that intellectually
interesting I just read the
documentation and realized oh to make
things prettier I need a t head a t body
and so forth but what's interesting here
is that if I go to my index here and
open this file called favorites. HTML
here is all of the data from last week's
Google spreadsheet which we exported as
CS and I manually before class converted
to just HTML it's indeed a table but
it's really not pretty like the columns
are really close together it's kind of
hard to distinguish one row from another
but this is just raw HTML written by me
now I could use CSS and some of the
tricks we just saw to maybe change font
size there's ways to change color
background color and a lot of things
like that but honestly other surely
other people in the world have presented
tabular data in pretty ways right I've
been to many websites that have prettier
tables than M can I maybe use someone
else's framework someone else's CSS
include it in my page but then stand on
their shoulders and just make my stuff
look prettier well I dare say I can let
me go ahead here and semi secretly open
up vs code again and let me grab a
slightly different version of favorites.
HTML that I also opened in advance
wherein I add this line of code instead
give me just a moment to foreground this
version and the data is is all the same
as before but I've added one of these
link tags and I'm not linking to my own
styles.css I'm using a popular Library
called bootstrap and bootstrap is just
one of many popular libraries out there
free at that that has a whole bunch of
CSS files and soon JavaScript files that
you can just use for free in your own
projects personally or professionally
that just make things look and behave
better without you having to reinvent
Wheels now to access their CSS I had to
read their documentation and grab this
very long URL here but it's the same
idea link a forre equals quote unquote
something and I read their documentation
and they told me to add this they told
me that if I want my tables to be
prettier I have to add a class attribute
to my own table tag and specify a little
weirdly but this is what bootstrap told
me to do a class called table and that
will make it a prettier bootstrap table
and if I want to stripe it like every
other row is gray instead of white just
to make it pop a little more visually I
can also add a second class separated by
a space called table striped that's all
I did I added line five and I changed
line nine and that is it the rest of the
hundreds of lines in favorites. HTML are
the same but if I go back here now and
reload the browser now thanks to
bootstrap voila like it's much prettier
now I can zoom out and that changes the
font size just locally for me and even
if you don't love their Aesthetics I
mean this is easily better than my own
there and it turns out we can can do
even better by adding interactivity to
this too but to do that we're going to
need one final language for today and
this one is an actual programming
language and we won't use it all that
much in cs50 but we introduce it here as
we begin web stuff because there's just
so many free libraries and professional
libraries that you can use just to make
your web applications fancier and more
interactive mobile applications as well
increasingly use HTML CSS and JavaScript
to power our iPhones and Android devices
as well so a quick tour some syntax and
then we'll conclude with just some
hopefully inspiring examples to give you
a taste of what JavaScript can do so
JavaScript supports conditionals just
like C and python before it if we rewind
to our scratch days here of course is a
conditional here is the corresponding
JavaScript code as of today it's pretty
much identical to see with the syntax
here uh if we had an if an if else in
scratch it looked like this in
JavaScript it's going to look like this
instead so it's a bit of a regression V
ofv python like the the parentheses are
back the curly braces are back the
semicolons I mentioned in CSS are also
back in JavaScript potentially but it's
familiar is the point here and it's a
different language that's frequently
used for the web whereas you can't use
python in the ways we're about to use
JavaScript it just wasn't designed for
that purpose meanwhile if you have an if
El it's else if else in scratch well in
JavaScript just like in C it's going to
look like this instead variables in
JavaScript of course are a thing too and
in scratch we might have initialized a
counter variable to Z in JavaScript a
few different ways to do this and just
the for now the keyword is let it's sort
of a polite way of asking for a variable
let uh counter equal zero semicolon so
you don't mention the type but you do
use a keyword here in this case called
let if you want to increment counter by
one few different ways in JavaScript you
can do this just like in C in JavaScript
you can do this just like in C and in
Python in JavaScript you can also get
this so plus plus is back so maybe that
counterbalances the other syntax as well
that was was not the case in Python
Loops are back of course in JavaScript
whereas in scratch you could repeat
three times like this in JavaScript it's
pretty much just like C the only
difference here is that you say let
instead of int for an example like this
meanwhile if you want to do something
forever in scratch in JavaScript just
like in C you say while true in this
case so this is to say we're sort of
comfortable spending relatively little
time on JavaScript at least for today's
purposes because syntactically it's
really the same as we've seen before
with maybe a slight variance here or
there but what's interesting today
arguably is just what kinds of things
you can do with it so with that said
what kinds of things can we do it's all
comes back to this picture if this is a
simple web page on the left and this is
the corresponding tree or Dom document
object model on the right that is the
tree the browser automatically creates
in memory or RAM for you JavaScript is
now a proper programming language that
lets us dynamically manipul ulate like
read data from this change this and this
is how Google for instance implements
your inbox they might have uh in your
inbox it's like a table so TR TR TR TR
probably something like that or heck
maybe div div div div using JavaScript
anytime they realize someone sent you
new mail they can create a new node a
new rectangle in memory and you the
human see a new div or a new TR again
and again and again so with JavaScript
you just have the ability to control the
user's experience and instead of like
I've been doing constantly hitting
reload in the page to see some new
content to see some new content
JavaScript can be running 247 so that
you can actually see all of these
changes live all right let's go about
writing some JavaScript code now instead
of writing it on the server and
executing it on the server we're going
to actually use a very common Paradigm
whereas JavaScript is actually executed
in the browser client side that is to
say we can actually start writing some
JavaScript code inside of our own HTML
file so that when a user visits that web
page with their browser not only is the
HTML and any CSS downloaded to the
user's browser so is that JavaScript
code so that it's executed indeed client
side on the browser rather than server
side as has been the case with python in
previous weeks well where do we go about
writing some JavaScript code let's go
ahead and revisit hello.html which
previously was a completely static
example that literally just said hello
title hello body indeed if I open this
up using HTTP server and view it now in
a separate tab all it said was exactly
that hello title in the tab and hello
body in the main part of the viewport so
to speak well let's make this example a
little more Dynamic so it doesn't just
say hello body but maybe says hello to
an actual person so let's go ahead and
do this let's go ahead and remove the
hardcoded hello body and let's actually
go ahead here and use a form tag but
we're not going to use this form in the
usual way whereby the data gets sent all
the way back to the server we're going
to Leverage control over this form
client side instead so I'm going to go
ahead and create this open form tag
close form tag inside of that let me
give myself a text input that's going to
have autocomplete equals quote unquote
off just to ensure that what I
previously type in my examples doesn't
reappear accidentally we're going to
autofocus it so that the cursor is
blinking right there in that text box
and this time I'm going to go ahead and
give it how about a uh placeholder of
quote unquote name to make clear that
prompting the user for their name and
then the type of this text box will be
the default or more explicitly here text
and then I'm going to have as we've seen
before a button the type of which is
submit also our typical default and then
inside of this button is going to be the
label how about something like uh how
about we'll call this greet so that's
what the button will actually say well
let me actually go back into my browser
tab let me reload this page and we
should now see a relatively simple form
whereby I have the cursor blinking on a
text inp input prompting the user for
their name and then a greet button that
I can click but if I click this button
now it's not going to do anything useful
because I haven't written any code to
tell the browser what to do when I click
that button but it turns out there's all
sorts of events in the world of
JavaScript that you can listen for so to
speak in fact here's just a list of some
of them anytime something changes in a
form field anytime the user clicks or
drags on something anytime the user
presses a key and maybe lifts their
finger up anytime the mouse goes down or
over or up on top of something or
anytime a form is submitted those are
events in the same way that we talked
about events back in week zero in
scratch and in JavaScript just like in
scratch where you can do something when
green flag clicked in JavaScript you can
write code that actually listens for any
of these events or more so with that
said let's go back to vs code here and
let's make a couple of changes instead
let's go ahead and add to this form a
new attribute that's not the best way to
do it but it's perhaps the simplest for
version one here and let's say onsubmit
do the following so onsubmit is an HTML
attribute and curiously its value inside
of the quotes there can actually be some
JavaScript code and let's go ahead now
and let's assume there exists a function
in the world called greet and what I
want to do is call that function right
then and there well now in JavaScript
how do I go about making that function
exist it doesn't come out of the box
just like print might or say might in
python or scratch respectively but I can
do this let me go up into the head of
this page inside of a script tag here
both open and close let me actually
write some JavaScript code and just so
it stands out I'm going to give myself a
couple of blank lines though not
strictly necessary and let me Define a
new function in JavaScript called greet
and this is the syntax in JavaScript for
creating your own function similar in
Python instead of saying defa in
JavaScript you just say function then
the name of the function and any
arguments within the parentheses
thereafter but I'm not going to pass in
any here then inside of curly braces
what I'm going to do is use a built-in
JavaScript function that comes with any
browser called alert it's not the best
or prettiest user interface but for now
it's going to get the job done what do I
want to say to the user well let's first
just say something simple like hello
comma World close quote semicolon
thereby alerting the user with precisely
that message now what I'm going to do
down here is make one other change I
don't want this form to actually get
submitted to the server just like we've
seen in the past when you submit a form
it often goes to something like
google.com/ search I actually want my
JavaScript code to take control over the
entire user experience of this form so
that I'm just using the form as a user
input mechanism not to actually send via
get or post this data to some other
server including my own so this is going
to look a little ugly but after calling
greet I'm actually going to do this
which I've read the documentation about
and I know that if you actually hardcode
return false here that just tells the
browser please don't actually submit the
form only call the Greet function all
right well let me go back to my browser
here let me reload this because I need
to download the latest version of the
JavaScript code and I'm just going to go
ahead without even typing my name I'm
going to click on the Greet button and
you'll see that Al be it a little
cryptically at the top we see an alert
that says hello world there's my ugly
URL of my code space there at the moment
but we do indeed see that string but
what I haven't of course done is taken
any actual name from the user so how can
we go about doing that well ideally I
want to alert the user with hello comma
David or hello comma Carter whatever a
name I type into that box so how can I
go about doing that well let me create a
variable called name and let me set it
equal to this function call
document. query
selector that comes with JavaScript
itself let me then in parenthesis pass
in an argument that is going to be huh
the ID the unique I need a unique
identifier for the thing I want to
select so let me actually go back to my
HTML code here and instead of giving
this form field a name like Q for query
let me actually use another HTML
attribute called ID where now I can call
this anything I want and for clarity I'm
just going to call this input element
uniquely name now up here in query
selector just like in CSS where you can
use hashes and dots and other symbology
in order to select certain nodes in your
Dom that is rectangles in that memory
tree well I can go ahead and select hash
name which again is just the Syntax for
uniquely selecting the element whose ID
is in this case name so you have the
hash up here you don't need the hash as
the value of the attribute down here on
line 20 and now if I want to actually
get the value of that text box I
literally just say do value so document
refers to the whole web page itself
query selector is a function that's
built into that object so to speak and
the value accessible via value just like
a c stru or even a python class allows
me to go inside of that text field and
get whatever the value the user has
typed in now as I've uh been able to do
in languages like python pretty Le
fairly readily I can concatenate this
name onto the string hello comma space
so as to form a complete phrase and
you'll notice here that I'm actually
using single quotes in my JavaScript
double quotes in my HTML this is perhaps
a common convention in JavaScript the
language does not care if you use double
quotes or single quotes but I dare say
single quotes are just more common and
so that's what I've done here all right
now as always I'm going to cross my
fingers go back to this page I'm going
to reload because I've changed the
JavaScript and I need my browser to
download it and now I'm going to type in
my name for instance David click greets
with fingers crossed and voila now I see
hello comma David all right so it turns
out that while functional this isn't the
best design and co-mingling your uh HTML
with your JavaScript script code AS with
this onsubmit attribute isn't
particularly clean it's better as with
CSS to keep your HTML over here your CSS
over here and your JavaScript now over
here so to speak and better still
perhaps even in some separate files so
how can I go about changing this a
little bit well let me go ahead and
actually let's go ahead and delete all
of this code for just a moment and let
me go and get rid of this on submit
Handler down here and really just
distill my HTML only into the HTML and
the attributes therefore and what I'm
instead going to do now is do this I can
use JavaScript to achieve the listening
for that submit event or that onsubmit
event I don't need to actually use HTML
for that I can use JavaScript entirely
so it turns out I can access some other
uh member of this document by doing
document. query selector again but this
time let's select the actual form tag
and it doesn't have an ID because it has
no ID in its HTML but it does have a tag
name so just like in CSS when you can
Target Elements by way of their name I'm
just going to select the one and only
form on this page by using that same
query selector function and now I'm
going to use another function that just
comes with JavaScript in the context of
browsers whereby once you select an
element like that form I can call add
event listener which is similar in
spirit to scratches when green flag
clicked or any block like that you can
then tell the browser what event you
want to listen for I want to listen for
the submit event so you don't say
onsubmit here now that we're in pure
JavaScript you just say submit and now I
can do something like this I can go
ahead and say call the following
function and I'm not even going to
bother giving this function a name and
that is allowed to in JavaScript as we
saw briefly in Python and what I'm going
to do now inside of curly braces after
that keyword function is the same kind
of code as before I'm going to do let
name equals document. query selector I'm
going to select that same IDE uh same
Name ID as before and get its value and
then I'm going to do alert and then pass
in hello comma a single quote again
after that concatenate with that the
name and then semicolon but I need to do
one other thing it turns out that this
function and if you read the
documentation for this technique
actually takes automatically a special
argument called by convention event and
this is just an a variable if you will
that refers to whatever event just
happened in this case it's of course
going to be submit but in other contexts
it might be a click event a mouse down
event or something else entirely so this
allows me now to do this which is a
little cryptic but you get used to these
conventions I can use that event
whatever it is and then prevent whatever
the default behavior is by calling a
special function called prevent default
with a capital D this is the alternative
to that Messier return fall semicolon
that I had inside of my HTML before so
all I've done here now is I've left all
of my HTML as pure HTML down here and
I've put all of my JavaScript code as
pure JavaScript up here this sort of
separation of concerns similar to what
we started doing with CSS just a bit ago
in order to keep those two languages
separate too well let me go back to my
browser here reload the page and
unfortunately there's a subtle mistake
I've made here let me go ahead and type
in David and click greet and
unfortunately nothing actually seems to
happen well maybe it's just my name
Carter greet and nothing seems to happen
that alert does not come up well why is
that well let me go back to vs code here
and point out that order of operations
in zscript matters similar in spirit to
C because on line seven I'm selecting
the form and trying to add an event
listener for submitting that form
unfortunately the form had better exist
at that moment in time but it doesn't
because just like in C and in some cases
python where the compiler or The
Interpreter reads the code top to bottom
notice that the form doesn't actually
exist and therefore get loaded into the
computer's memory until line 19 so we've
got to kind of reorder these somehow now
maybe the simplest way to do this would
just be to perhaps do something like
this let me scroll back up to my script
tag and perhaps a little more explicitly
move it into the order in which I want
it to be executed so I'm going to go
below my form and inside of my body
which is actually okay for JavaScript
here and just use that same code and
assuming I didn't make any typos let's
go back to the browser click reload
again to get the latest typee in my name
again using that purely JavaScript
solution and the only change I made was
I move the code from up here to down
here clicking greet now and wow it's now
back we get the alert with hello comma
David so those kinds of things those
kinds of principles matter at least when
we're back in this world but there's
other Solutions too and just so that
you've seen it because it's a common
convention in libraries as well let me
undo that change and put that script tag
back in the head or really anywhere else
in the page where it might be
and let me propose that there's one
other way to solve this problem to
postpone that code on line 7 through 11
getting executed until really the whole
Dom the tree is ready to go and the
Syntax for this might be as follows I
can do document and I can add to the
document a an event listener that's
going to listen for something a little
special and I always have to look this
up myself to remember the spelling and
the capitalization but it turns out that
the browser itself once it's done
loading all of your HTML top to bottom
left right it will raise an event called
Dom content loaded capitalized exactly
as such and if you want to call some
function and I don't even need an event
argument in this case you can open curly
braces just as before and put inside of
those curly braces the code that you
want to execute only once the dumbs
content has been loaded top to bottom
and now let me just finish my thought
with a closed curly brace Clos
parenthesis and semicolon it gets a
little Annoying to visually line all of
this up but I think I'm still good and
now even though this code is at the top
of my file or really above the form tag
itself I think we're okay so let's go
back to the browser here reload the page
type in David and click greet and we
still get the same correct behavior and
so this is just a very common Paradigm
to use these kinds of events to listen
and listen and listen for something to
happen and then only do something once
that thing has transpired all right well
let's take one more step with JavaScript
code before we take a look at what's
really fun about this language and what
you can do with browsers in particular
by just cleaning things up a little bit
further I'm going to go back into the
code here and I'm actually going to
remove uh or cut all of this code out of
the hello.html file itself and I'm going
to change my script tag to have nothing
in between the open and close tag but I
am going to give it a source attribute
and let's go ahead and call this for
instance hello.js sojs would be the
convention for the file extension for a
Javascript file and even though this is
a little weird that we have the script
tag and a source attribute then nothing
in between the open and close tag this
is indeed the convention when you want
to put all of your code in a separate
file and let me go ahead and do that let
me go ahead and open my terminal window
create a new file called
hello.js and then in that file I'm just
going to paste the very code that I just
cut from the previous file so no changes
to the code all I'm doing is factoring
it out and now I'm doing something just
like our CSS factorization before which
confusingly use the link tag this uses
the script tag this just now allows me
to collaborate with someone like Carter
or someone else so that they can do the
JavaScript code I can do the HTML maybe
a third person can do the CSS and indeed
maybe we can build even grander things
by uh designing things in this way all
right well let me go back to my browser
again reload the page I shouldn't see
any visual changes but if I type in my
name again David and click greet this
still now works and what my browser has
just done underneath the hood is not
only download the uh hello.html file as
always because there's now this script
tag that's referencing the source of
another file just like an image tag
might reference the source of an image
the browser is automatically helping me
out by loading that into its memory as
well and now how about one final example
and for this one I'm going to go ahead
and not write it live but open it up as
prepared in advance just to show you
what you can do by listening for some of
these other events as well like the key
up the finger going down the finger
going up and listening for exactly that
so as the user is typing something you
can do something interesting as well I'm
going to go back into my directory
listing here and I click on this Source
a directory which has all of the
examples that I wrote here in advance
and I'm going to scroll down to one
called hello 5. HTML and in hello 5 now
we've gotten rid of the button and we
just have this text box but notice now
what happens if I start typing my name
as d a v i d D I'm not typing enter at
all and in fact if I start deleting and
I change my mind and start typing
Carter's name notice now that the web
page the Dom inside of the computer's
memory is now automatically updating
itself so it's not even listening it
would seem for a submit event anymore
but maybe for a key up event instead so
let me go back to VSS code here open my
terminal window and in my source a
directory let me open up hello 5. HTML
inside of the script tag you'll see some
code that's similar in spirit to before
whereby I'm adding an event listener to
the document waiting for the whole Dom's
content to be loaded but then inside of
that function I'm now doing this I'm
creating a variable called input and
selecting from the document the one and
only input tag that we saw just a moment
ago I'm then adding on line 11 in event
listener for key up which is exactly
that gesture so that I can execute some
additional code anytime the human lists
their finger from the keyboard after
typing a key what do I then do well I'm
going to go ahead it seems and declare
another variable called name and I'm
just going to select some P tag on the
page and now we didn't really see a P
tag so I think it's time to look at the
HTML if I scroll down to the bottom of
the page where my actual HTML is you'll
see that there's just a form tag and no
onsubmit Handler anymore as before
there's just an input tag and no button
at all but there is on line 29 here an
open and close P tag just so I have an
empty placeholder in which to put
something like hello David or hello
Carter so that's why now on line 12 I
can define a variable called name and I
can select that P tag so that what do I
want to do well if inside of the input
there's a value so this is essentially
checking for null or the absence of a
string so if input. value does not equal
nothing that is there is a value in that
text box well this syntax here on line
14 is a very clever way of doing the
following go into that name tag that is
to say the empty par paragraph change
the inner HTML of it the HTML inside of
it to be literally this hello comma and
then just so you've seen an additional
piece of syntax this is similar to
Python's F strings the syntax is a
little weird in JavaScript you actually
use not single quotes not double quotes
but back ticks which on a US English
keyboard are typically the top leftand
key of your keyboard or thereabouts and
using dollar sign curly braces just like
the curly braces alone in Python allows
us to plug in whatever the value is of
that input however if there's no value
there it looks like I'm just going to
say hello whoever you are and in fact we
can see that behavior now is I delete
delete delete delete delete delete and
nothing's there now that if condition is
no longer true and so we see this
default value instead so this is only to
say that by harnessing these various
events that are constantly happening on
most any web page we can now register
code just like we did way back in
scratch to actually listen for those
events and do something with them now it
turns out we can do some interesting
things even using third party coat and
just as we used bootstrap a bit ago to
make our table prettier allow me to
propose that we also take a look at this
version of favorites as well let me go
back into my source a directory and open
up favorites 2 which I made in advance
which looks almost the same though I've
zoomed in here a bit but you'll notice
somewhat subtly over the leftmost column
in this table you'll see now this arrow
in Gray pointing up and pointing down
previously those were not there all I
had was a static HTML table with all of
this data sorted in whatever order it
was inputed the other day in that form
but now notice what I can do if I want
to sort in uh one order I can click this
Arrow or the other order I can sort in
this Arrow so essentially doing it
chronologically forward or backward now
how is that sorting happening it's
presumably based on all of the
timestamps that were registered when we
submitted that Google form just a bit
ago um uh when it was live but now using
JavaScript it turns out that we can use
some logic somehow and sort this data by
the same and you don't get that
automatically just by using HTML alone
now how did I achieve that well it turns
out if I go ahead and close these hello
files and in vs code let's open up uh
favorites 2. HTML you'll see that all of
the HTML is actually the same if I
scroll down and down through this file
but I added a little something
interesting at top I copied and pasted
the appropriate URLs and HTML tags from
bootstraps documentation and you'll see
here that I have a file called not only
bootstrap.css but also
bootstrap.min.js as well as a couple of
other things as well that allows me
ultimately using third-party libraries
to add some special HTML attributes that
those libraries told me to add and then
as soon as those libraries detect the
presence of these attributes now on my
own raw data they do their thing and
javascrip defy not a technical term the
entire table and now make it interactive
and not static so you'll see here that
the Aesthetics of the table are as
before table and table striped but I'm
adding now another HTML attribute called
Data toggle whose value is table and I
know that only from the documentation of
these libraries indicating that's that's
how I can now enable this table to be
interactive as I can too by adding data
sortable equals quote unquote true on
specifically the timestamp column and
the only thing unfamiliar here perhaps
is I'm using t P for table heading as
opposed to TD as I do elsewhere but
that's all that it takes to now focus on
the raw data you want to present and let
someone else do the heavy lifting of
actually implementing the logic well
let's end with just a look at what more
you can do with Java script and just how
powerful it is when you combine a
language like this with the data and the
uh user interface you want to convey
let's go ahead and open up within Source
a directory something called background.
HTML now this interface here is quite
simple it just has three buttons RG and
B and the background of course noticed
by default is just white but when I
click on the r the background turns red
when the I click on the G it turns green
and the blue it turns blue and again and
again so how is this working well if you
think back again to the available events
perhaps I'm just listening for a click
on those buttons and then doing
something with maybe the CSS of the page
to allow me to see those different
colors so in fact let's go back to vs
code here and let's open up background.
HTML and in here you'll see some simple
HTML at the top just three buttons but
I've given each a unique ID so that I
can reference it in code and then inside
of a script tag here below because I
didn't bother with the uh Dom content
loaded event here notice that I'm doing
the following I'm creating a variable
called body that lets me select the body
tag I then have in these three line some
code that handles red what am I doing
well I'm selecting from the document
whatever h HTML tag has unique ID of red
and then I'm adding an event listener
for any click on that button and anytime
someone clicks on that red button I call
this function anonymously it doesn't
even have or need a name and this syntax
here is powerful because now in
JavaScript I can alter the CSS of my
page by doing body which is the tag that
I selected two lines ago accessing its
style accessing its background color
property and setting it equal to quote
unquote red and I do the same down below
for green I do the same down below for
blue and the only thing worth noting
here is that in CSS it turns out it's
the case that the CSS property for the
background color of a page is actually
background Das color in all lower case
with a hyphen in between unfortunately
in the world of JavaScript a hyphen
would be mistaken for subtraction like
background minus color which would be
wrong so the convention in JavaScript is
when you're trying to manipulate CSS you
take whatever the property name is uh
font size background color and you
change it into so-called camel case here
you get rid of The Hyphen and you
capitalize the subsequent words like
color in this case here all right how
about another well it turns out back in
the day back in my day there was a HTML
tag that would actually allow you to do
this create blinking text on a screen
it's rather unpleasant at this rate
certainly but how might this work well
it turns out in JavaScript if we take a
look at the blink. HTML file here we'll
see that you can in your HTML do
something literally as simple as hello
world in the body but then you can call
this function here turns out just like
document there's another Global special
variable you can use in JavaScript and
browsers called window which refers to
all things related to the window itself
the window comes with a set interval
function which lets you do exactly that
set an interval in milliseconds and
after every expiration of that interval
some function will be called for you so
in this case it's saying every 50
milliseconds but let's actually slow
that down now to 500 milliseconds or for
one half a second call a function called
blink notice I do not have parentheses
after the blink name because I don't
want to call blink now I want to tell
JavaScript to call the function called
blink every 500 milliseconds now we'll
see in a moment what that code looks
like but let's go back to the page and
reload and you'll see now that it's a
more pleasant blinking if that's even
the case every half second because I'm
now firing that event that is I'm uh
calling that function now every 500
milliseconds instead how am I doing that
well this same script tag I've invented
my own blink function this is has the
distinction back in the day of actually
being an HTML tag and among the few tags
that the world removed and got rid of so
that it's no longer used because it's
not all that user friendly but down here
what am I doing I'm getting the body of
the document itself with this variable
and then I'm checking two CSS properties
that we didn't talk about before but it
turns out that you can check and set the
visibility of an element in JavaScript
by going into that tag checking its
style and getting its visibility uh
property and if it happens to equal
hidden the next line of code here 13
sets it equal to visible instead else if
it's not hidden it must already be
visible and so line 17 flips it the
other way and changes it to Hidden here
left hand right hand clearly not talking
no idea why the opposite of visible Is
Not Invisible it's indeed visible and
hidden but this just allows you every
time this function is called to change
the property from one value to another
achieving that blinking effect you can
do even more powerful things that you
and I take for granted every day let's
go into Source 8 and go to autocom
complete. HTML which I wrote in advance
and this is a page that also loads into
memory a really big dictionary that you
might recall from problem set five and
if I go ahead and type in something like
c a t you'll notice dynamically an
unordered bulleted list appearing below
the text box that shows you all of the
words in that dictionary from pet 5 that
start with c and then CA and then T just
like the autocomplete you see every day
on your phone in Google or websites like
it how is that working well probably I'm
listening for the key press going up as
soon as that key is pressed I'm probably
searching through a big array uh really
of all of those words maybe using linear
search maybe binary search if uh faster
than that and then looking for any
string in that array that starts with C
or CA or c a t and then I'm generating
automattic IC Ally the HTML therefore
but perhaps most familiar nowadays is
just how much your phone and your laptop
know about you and let me go into a
final example here in Source 8 called
geolocation HTML which is a term of art
that just refers to figuring out your
geography for instance your GPS
coordinates now here we have a third and
final Global variable that your browser
provides you with called Navigator and
in Navigator there's a special object
called geolocation that comes with a
function called get current position
so if you call Navigator geolocation dog
getcurrent position and then pass in a
function of your own that doesn't need a
name but does take an argument in this
case I called it position as soon as the
browser or as soon as the phone has
figured out where in the world that user
is with that browser at some latitude
and longitude the browser will
automatically call that function for you
and you can do anything you want with
the position that comes back the
latitude and longitude respectively so
I'm going to use a function that's not
often that help but for our purposes
today it's just going to write to the
document itself to my big rectangular
region whatever the latitude is then a
comma and then the longitude as well so
if we go back with this final flourish
into Source 8 open up geolocation HTML
you'll see that my browser first wants
my permission to let this website my own
know my location I'm going to go ahead
and click allow crossing my fingers
because it might take a moment for the
phone or the laptop to figure it out and
it looks like according to Google I am
right this moment with my Mac at
latitude longitude 42375 comma
7111 let's go ahead and highlight and
copy that let's go to a website like
Googl maps.com crossing our fingers if
you've never done this you can search
for GPS coordinates too let's hit enter
and amazing we are indeed in Sanders
Theater roughly there standing on this
stage on Halloween and that then is week
eight we will see you next time happy
Halloween
nothing
go buffering
okay Josh
[Music]
nice it's Moy no oh
wait that was amazing
Josh uh um Sophie
[Music]
amazing that was
perfect I think I
hey to
you
[Music]
oh that was amazing thank you all so
good
[Music]
all right this is cs50 and this is
already week nine which is our second to
last indeed this is really the last week
where you'll learn in this class how to
program but indeed it's this week that's
really meant to be the the pedagogical
climax of like all of these various
languages we've been looking at all of
these various techniques all of this
syntax so that at the end of cs50 in
just a few weeks you indeed feel that
you didn't take a class on C and you
didn't take a class on python but you
really more generally took a class on
programming because indeed we know
already about half of you uh will go on
to study computer science further but
half of you will not and indeed all of
your programming chops here on out
theoretically will have a foundation in
what we been doing these past many weeks
but here on out it's really going to be
up to you to learn some new fangled
language when it comes out or to follow
some new trend when some language
eclipses the ones we've been using as
more popular as more appropriate for
problems you want to solve and so today
really is about synthesizing so many of
the past few weeks but doing it in the
context of web programming which For
Better or For Worse is so very much
invogue nowadays both on our laptops and
phones and indeed the languages we
looked at in recent weeks are used not
only to make websites but also full
fledged applications and app stores and
the like so this really will be the
culmination of those past several weeks
and indeed we'll even talk about some
familiar Concepts like shopping carts
when you're on Amazon and these things
called cookies when you're visiting
websites all of those topics too will
come into play and you'll have an
understanding of what all that means
from the ground up so how did we get
here well just last week we focused on
HTML and CSS primarily which are not
programming languages they're just about
Aesthetics structuring your data
presenting your data and so forth um and
we served the web pages we wrote using
this program HTTP server this is just
one such program there's dozens hundreds
of different web servers that you can
use out there this is just a super
simple one we pre-installed in your
codes space for you in vs code so that
you can just serve up web pages at the
end of last week two though we teased
JavaScript a full-fledged programming
language that you can use to manipulate
the users experience for the better to
make things more Dynamic and interactive
by actually running code in the user
users's browser on their Mac their PC
their phone as opposed to server side
which up until now is where all of our
code in C and python has been written so
you're writing code on a server you're
serving code from a server but now with
HTML CSS and JavaScript it's getting
executed in a browser but today we're
going to give you one final feature of
python or really languages like it that
you can also use code on the server to
generate automatically dynamically the
HTML uh the JavaScript the CSS that you
actually want the user to rece receive
you don't have to hardcode everything as
you have when making your own homepage
well let's consider what what some of
the building blocks were last week so
here's a sample URL and over here slash
is sort of the default page on any web
server it might be index.html it might
be something else that's just a
convention but it refers to whatever the
default actually is you can visit of
course when any browser like a URL that
ends in file. HTML or something else.
HTML and that literally means your
browser wants this file on this server
or of course we saw that it can be a
folder and inside of that folder is
presumably some default file name like
again index.html or you can be more
explicit like folder file. HTML and
these more generally we just called
paths and indeed a path is just a
location on your Mac your PC or on a
server of some piece of information but
today we're just going to rename this
only to use other common terminology but
they're really just synonyms today we're
going to refer to those same things as
routes because now today we're going to
ultimately replace HT PTP server which
just serves up static content that you
all write with your own web server like
now you will be the ones controlling
what it is the server does in response
to the user in uh requests so that you
can respond interactively and
dynamically but we're still going to see
techniques like this these were our
so-called HTTP parameters they're
everything that comes after a question
mark in a URL and it can be like key
equals value and an example was what
when we played with Google what was the
key and what was the value
that I first tried any
recollection I was searching for cats
and so the key I figured that was Q
because that's what Larry and Sergey who
created Google years ago decided the
name would be of the HTML text box that
you type your query into and if I type
cat for cat the value of that would end
up in the URL for Google as being
question mark cat equals value and I
mentioned that it's often the case that
you want to send two different inputs to
a server and this is why I propose that
you just keep an eye out for Amper Sands
and and Ampersand separate these key
value pairs but again this is the same
darn Paradigm as before and we've seen
this so many times right key value pairs
in dictionaries in Python we've seen uh
HTML attributes and their values we've
seen CSS properties and their values
it's all the same thing associating
something with something else even
though every language every person seems
to have their own uh vernacular for it
it really is just the same idea this
associating of something with something
else we'll continue to see and here to
be concrete were the
HTTP lines of text that were in those
virtual envelopes if you will if I were
indeed selecting trying to search for
something like cats on Google this
recall was the message that got sent to
the server by my browser in order to
tell Google to please search for not
dogs but in this case cats now what is
HTTP server been doing for us well it's
just been serving up HTML files CSS
files maybe some js or JavaScript files
but it has been ignoring any HTTP
parameters like HTTP server does not
take user input why well what's it going
to do with it because you already wrote
the HTML you already wrote the CSS like
there's no decisions to be made until we
introduce a proper programming language
on the server and so we're going to move
away now from this simple HTTP server
program and introduce you to your own
server that's going to handle the
parsing that is the extraction of these
key value pairs so that you and I don't
have to write python code all of a
sudden that like analyzes this stuff
figures out what pages requested the key
value pairs all of that were still going
to get for free by just using the right
framework and so today we revisit python
uh which we've now used in some form the
past few weeks and indeed it's kind of
been the glue that allows us to stitch
together some of our own logic we saw it
with SQL we're going to now see it with
HTML CSS and even JavaScript if we want
and we're also going to see another
language today not a programming
language called Ginga and this is going
to be a common Paradigm in the real
world whereby different languages
different libraries different Frameworks
often like borrow from each other or
they use uh technologies that someone
else wrote just so they don't have to
reinvent that wheel so flask is just a
framework that is a third party Library
it's pretty popular nowadays it's
relatively simple which is why we use it
in cs50 if you've programmed before cs50
Jango is another popular framework or
library in the python sta space but it's
a little more complicated so we focus on
flask and Ginga we'll see is not a
programming language it's just going to
be some syntax thankfully familiar with
curly braces that allow us to use
placeholders in our actual web pages so
again you'll wrap your minds all
eventually around where the lines are
among these various Technologies but
these are not the interesting ideas the
interesting ideas are the ones we'll
focus on in code but starting today
instead of running HTTP server to serve
up a static website we'll have you start
running literally flask space run in
your terminal window to run your own web
server that's implemented in Python
using this flask framework so bootstrap
was a library for making your CSS and
JavaScript prettier and more interactive
flask is a framework or library for just
making your python code more pleasant to
use since you're borrowing features from
someone else all right so how can we go
about doing this well if you are to
write your very own web application your
own amazon.com your own google.com in
Python using flask minimally you need to
have a file called app.py by convention
which is where all your python code goes
and then a folder called templates which
is where all of your templates go and
for now your templates are just your
HTML files so if we're going to now
start building more interesting
interactive things like google.com or
amazon.com we need to be able to execute
code on the server and so this is the
convention it's not index.html anymore
necessarily it's these two things at the
top level with that said we'll quickly
see that there's some other conventions
and in my examples online and in the uh
problem set nine you'll see another file
called requirements.txt which is just a
text file that allows you to enumerate
all of the thirdparty libraries your
application might want to use it's a
convention so that the server can like
automatically install things for you
without you having to do it manually and
then static is going to be where
literally your static content goes so if
you've got images for your web
application if you've got JavaScript
files CSS files by convention that goes
in static these are just conventions
like all of this can be changed but this
is like the way to do things so we'll
introduce you to the defaults all right
so what does this mean how for instance
could I go about implementing my own web
application using python that somehow
spits out a message like Hello World all
right well turns out just this now we'll
tease this apart in just a moment but
this is the content of a sample app.py
file that apparently uses some Library
stuff like familiar syntax from
something import something else we've
seen that before with csvs and other
libraries this is somewhat new syntax
but it's kind of copy paste for now this
is definitely new syntax and kind of
weird with the at sign here but we'll
see this again and again today and it's
just copy paste initially until you
understand what it's doing for you but
at least there's some familiar stuff
here like index.html is still going to
be with us but it's going to be up to us
when and how to show it to the user so
let's make this more real let me go over
to vs code here and let me go ahead and
create a how about we'll do this in
hello let me do makeer hello to make a
new folder called hello and I'm going to
CD into it just to isolate all of these
files to the same directory so that we
have different apps today and different
folders and now I'm going to do code of
let's do this actually let's do our
maker templates. HTM ah sorry not
templates. HTML let me rename that to
templates using the MV command this has
nothing to do with web programming this
is me making typos so if I type LS now
I've got a folder called templates all
right in there let's create a file
called index.html that is going to be
super simple and pretty much copy paste
from last week let me hide my terminal
window and let me just very quickly whip
up a simp simple hello world page using
my HTML tag Lang will equal English then
inside of this I'm going to have a head
tag inside of this I'm going to have a
title tag and I'm just going to call
this thing hello uh I'm going to then
have a body and in this I'm only going
to say something simple like hello comma
world and just so this is mobile
friendly recall that we touched on these
meta tags so just in case you after
class play with your mobile device
instead of your laptop I'll do name
equals quote unquote
viewport uh viewport and and content
equals and I never remember this I'm
literally reading it off of a cheat
sheet initial scale equals 1 width
equals device width and this is just
this magical incantation that says to
the browser like size things
appropriately for the size of the device
it blows up the font sizes a bit all
right so that's what I would have done
last week and I would have served this
web page by running HTTP server in the
same directory and boom I would see that
HTML but let's now start to take some
control over the user's experience and
for now it's going to be underwhelming
it's just going to always say hello
world but in a moment version two is
going to say hello David or hello Carter
a bit more dynamically and we'll quickly
escalate from there to just more
interesting applications as well
culminating with things like cookies and
shopping carts and the like so let me go
back into my terminal window and as
promised let me create another file
called
app.py and this is where now I need to
implement the web server I'm going to
run using this flask framework and for
now I'm just going to kind of do some
copy paste from uh what we saw on the
slide a moment ago from the flask
Library which we've pre-installed for
you I'm going to import a uh function
called flask capital F it's subtle but
it's important there and I'm also going
to import a few other things a function
called render template and another
variable called request and the only way
I know this is from having taught this
before read the documentation followed a
tutorial like you wouldn't know this
unless someone told you or you read how
to do this this but what this means is
that this Library called flask has three
things in it a function called flask
capital f a function called render
template and a variable built into it
called request and this is going to be
all the building blocks I need to
implement my own web server the
convention in flask when you want to
create a web app in Python is you create
a variable by convention called app and
then you assign it the return value of
that flask function capital F and pass
into it underscore uncore name uncore
underscore which is weird but we have
seen this before a few weeks ago anyone
recall when and why we mentioned uncore
uncore name uncore
uncore yeah I think was
it name or something yeah if we wanted
to check if the name of the file was
itself main so that we avoided a
situation where if you're writing your
own Library code you don't want your
code to be executed automatically you
want to potentially execute the main
function and that was a solution to that
problem here for today's purposes this
is just the way you do it underscore
underscore name underscore uncore refers
to the current file and so this is just
a little trick that says turn this file
into a flask application that's all it
is and for now uh that line suffices all
right what do I want to do after that
well now I'm in charge of the web server
I need to write the code that decides
based on the browsers request what file
or files I'm going to send from the
server to the browser last week http
server did all of this for us just based
on the file name but today I'm going to
take over control over that process and
the way I do that is as follows I say
app. route with weirdly an at sign in
front of it this is known in python as a
decorator and it's a feature of python
not a flask that we just didn't
introduce in weeks past but it's a
special it's a handy trick to do what
we're about to do the route I want to
Define is quote unquote slash so that is
here is code I want the server to
execute whenever I user visits forward
slash the default page of the website
well what code do I want them to execute
well I want them to execute a function
and I can therefore Define in Python a
function I can technically call this
thing anything I want X or Y or Z but
because they're accessing the default
page otherwise known as the index of the
site I'm going to just more reasonably
call this function index but just a
convention you could call it anything
you want but X Y or Z is probably a bad
stylistic choice it doesn't need to take
any arguments in this case and the only
thing this code this function is going
to do is for now let's go ahead and have
it return hello world quote unquote and
that's it all right now let me go into
my terminal window let me go ahead and
do flask run in the same directory that
has appy and hit enter I'm going to see
some cryptic output but including a URL
of my code space and if I open that URL
after hovering over it I'll indeed see
hello world as you might hope but let me
do this let me go ahead and rightclick
on the page and click view page source
which if you haven't done before shows
you all of the HTML for a page however
pretty or messy it is and that's it
there's no HTML that I've spit out it's
just quote unquote hello world well if I
actually want to spit out a full web
page which is not a big deal here
because who cares it's just the text
anyway but if I want to spit out a whole
file let me do this I want to return
essentially the contents of index.html
which have all of the tags I want the
mobile friend stuff and all of that well
I can't just return index.html but I can
return this render template quote
unquote
index.html and per the documentation for
flask this render template function will
go find that file for me in my templates
folder by convention it will open it up
and then it will spit the whole thing
out to the browser for me so I can keep
all my HTML in one place and all my
python code in this one place so now if
I go back to my browser and reload I
don't think I'll really see a difference
because it's the same text ultimately
but if I view page Source now notice
that ah there is all of the HTML that
was just sent to the browser so this is
only to say we have the building blocks
the puzzle pieces if you will via which
to now store all of our HTML in one
place and presumably CSS JavaScript and
so forth but then serve up whatever we
want even though I'm just blindly
spitting out
index.html so before we proceed any
questions on this which again I claim is
like my manual version of what HTTP
server was doing for us automatically
last week but this is how you do it
yourself any
questions all right well let's make it
more interesting which we could not do
with HTTP server and HTML alone why
don't we go ahead and do this let me
visit the same URL and I'm going to zoom
in and your url will differ from my code
space but it's going to end similarly
here I'm going to do slash question mark
name equals David for instance or Q
equals cats or name equals Carter any
key value pair I want I'm going to
append after a slash and a question mark
thereby providing user input to the
server albe it in a very user unfriendly
way no one's going to normally do this
in their browser enter nothing changes
here it just says hello world but
wouldn't it be nice if it says hello
David or equivalently if I zoom in here
again and change David to Carter and hit
enter wouldn't it be nice if it says
hello Carter instead so we need some
dynamism there and here's now python is
going to be our friend if I want to
access the HTTP parameters that the user
has provided via the URL be it Q equals
cats or name equals David I can use this
special variable I already preemptively
imported earlier and I can do this if
there is an HTTP parameter called name
in what I'm going to call request. args
then I'm going to go ahead and create a
variable called name and I'm going to
set it equal to request. args bracket
name else if there is no quote unquote
name key in this special variable called
request. args I'm going to just assume
that the user's name is World by default
now what's going on here well it turns
out that flask provides us with this
special variable called request. ARs and
in there is all of the key value pairs
that might have come in via the URL so
if you had to guess what type of data or
what data type is request. args that's
its name and here is in context line n
might provide a clue in Python what data
type might request. args
be
yeah uh it's not going to be an array or
a list because those are always in every
language we've seen numerically indexed
but you're
close someone else it's a dictionary so
a dictionary is similar syntactically to
a list in Python but instead of numeric
indices like 012 you can literally use
strings like quote unquote name now
that's a bit of a white lie it is a
dictionary but it's flask's special
fancy version of a dictionary but the
syntax via which you can access it is
exactly the same and I actually this is
a typo I didn't mean to say names there
I meant to say name singular but
otherwise I think the code is correct
this is going to on line eight check if
there's a key called name in request.
ARs and if so it's going to set it equal
to that value otherwise it's going to
default to world I deliberately did not
do this I added this IFL
and did not do this why what error might
happen if I just blindly grab
name exactly if there was nothing at the
end of the URL that was of the form
question mark name equals someone then
there would be no name key and this is
uh you know a couple weeks back but this
would give you one of those annoying key
errors when you get a trace back because
you screwed up because you used a string
that doesn't exist that's why I'm just
proactively trying to avoid that
situation just like I'm might have a
couple of weeks ago so even though it's
more verbose this is just much more
defensive so that I don't accidentally
index into a dictionary where there is
no key but we'll see how we can tighten
this up to be not four lines but one but
I think now I can do this wouldn't it be
nice if now in my index.html file which
recall is in my templates folder
wouldn't it be nice if I could do the
equivalent in C of like a percent s here
for instance or in Python something like
this name well it's close and this is
just because different humans invent
different languages invent different uh
Frameworks the Syntax for this in flask
is to actually do whoops two curly
braces and then name of the variable
inside of it why it's just probably
someone figured what are the odds that a
normal person is ever going to use two
curly braces at once versus just one so
this is probably decreasing the
probability that people actually want to
Output literal curly braces like this so
it's similar in spirit to Python's F
strings it's similar in spirit to C's
percent s it's similar in spirit to
sql's question marks same idea slightly
different syntax and this there is
ginger so it's not programming code per
se it's just a template and indeed
that's why this folder is called
templates it is sort of like a a
blueprint for what I want to be spit out
to the user but I've got these
placeholders like this variable that I
want to plug into that value now this
alone is not enough watch what happens
if I go back to my other browser and I
reload the page after changing up here
let's do name equals David again enter
nothing outputs after the hello comma so
it seems that the name variable doesn't
exist yet and that's why indeed if I do
view page Source you can see what was
sent to the browser something's wrong
with my placeholder but I just need to
be a little more explicit as to what I
want to send where so it turns out that
the render template function takes not
just one argument the name of the
template you want to spit out but it
takes after that with commas all of the
placeholders you want to plug in so for
instance if you want the placeholder to
be this literally placeholder inside of
those curly braces you can then specify
as the second argument to rep uh render
template a placeholder named argument
equals whatever the name is so name is
the variable in the lines above
placeholder is the name of my literal
placeholder in the curly braces and so
now if I go back to my browser and
reload this with still quote unquote
with still question mark name equals
David in the URL now I indeed see hello
comma David and if I zoom in here and
let me move over here let me type in
Carter and hit enter now I see Hello
Carter instead now this is a little
unnecessary to explicitly call the
placeholder placeholder especially if
you want to have two or three of them so
you can actually call this anything you
want and I'm going to change it back to
name which is a little more
straightforward the only weird thing
here is that now you'll see that you're
writing code like this and this is
correct and this is the norm it just
looks weird but the thing on the left of
the equal sign is the placeholder you're
using in the template the thing on the
right can be any value you want
including a variable so even though I'm
naming them exactly the same which looks
stupid admittedly like this is what
people tend to do just because it's uh
simpler than introducing another word
like placeholder any questions now on
this
any questions on these
placeholders no all right well let's
tighten this up a little bit and see if
we can't get things to be more Dynamic
still let me propose now that instead of
outputting instead of using this
condition which made a very simple idea
like very verbose with four different
lines it turns out there's an easier way
to do this you can actually still create
a variable called name and you can set
it equal to request. args but instead of
just blindly indexing into to that
dictionary it turns out that request.
ARS comes with a function as well called
get you can pass it an argument that
tells you what value you want to get and
by default if there is no key called
name in that dictionary this function
will not throw a key error it's just
going to return none an O the special V
the Special Value in Python so it avoids
a bug in your code but it tightens up
four lines into one but even nicer if
you read the documentation
the get function can also take a
explicit default value so if you don't
want none to be on the screen like hello
comma blank or I mean that would be
weird too you can just put in a default
value per the documentation of this
function like world so now we've gone
from four lines to just one so arguably
it's better designed and if I go back to
the browser now still with Carter in the
URL and hit reload same thing happens
but we notice this suppose I uh get rid
of the name parameter altogether and hit
enter now it goes to the default instead
world so it's just a little better a
little better designed than doing it the
other way instead all right how about we
take things up one more Notch and how
about we introduce multiple routes and
actually introduce perhaps a form to the
mix because again no normal person is
going to like visit a URL and add a
slash and a question mark and their name
like that's not how browsers work uh
well that's how browsers work that's not
how humans interact with browsers you
and I use a form to quickly instead so
now things can get a little more
interesting when making our own web
application cuz maybe we could do
something like this let me go and zoom
out again let me go back to my code here
and let me move this around and focus
now on the index.html file instead of
just this placeholder why don't we go
ahead and give ourselves a form like
we've played with a little bit in the
past be it for Google or something else
and let's do this uh form and inside of
this form let's have an input and the
name of this input will be quote unquote
name so that too is confusing but inputs
have name attributes but this is a
person's name so I'm saying name equals
name here so just a messy world of
semantics and let me go ahead and make
this a text box by default and then let
me give myself a button whose default
type will be submit and the name of this
button will be greet for instance so
let's see what happens here but let me
change app.py to just be the original
simpler I'm not passing in any
placeholders now and I'm going to even
get rid of this I'm just going to rewind
to the first version of this for
Simplicity let's now change the url to
get rid of Carter and myself so we just
go to slash and hit enter and now we
have a super simple form again all right
this is not super userfriendly but
there's some nice enhancements we can
make for instance like we can uh for
instance turn off autocomplete
especially if I want to type David and
Carter manually and I don't want it
finishing my thought during class uh we
can do autofocus which puts the cursor
there BL linking by default which is
nice cuz then the human doesn't have to
deal with that um and then we can even
have a placeholder attribute placeholder
equals name so that it's like built in
instructions for this thing and so now
if I go back to the other tab nothing's
changed yet because I have to download
the HTML again reload okay now it's a
little more user friendly it says name
and light gray the cursor is blinking
and I'm sort of ready to go but this
form hasn't been wired up to go anywhere
yet and so let's do this let's for
instance say that the action of this
form
is not going to be something like
google.com which we did last time with
for cats I am now going to be both the
front end and the back end of this
website the front end is what the human
sees the web page the graphics the forms
the back end is the stuff the human
typically doesn't see the python code
the SQL code the server itself but now
I'm in control of both sides of the
experience the HTML and also the routes
so let's just propose that we invent our
own route and instead of calling it SL
search like Google does let's call it
SLG greet and let me specify that the
method this form will use which is
technically the default will be get and
confusingly it is lowercase get even
though in the envelope we keep talking
about virtually it's actually capitals
again left hand wasn't talking to right
hand when these things were decided all
right so all I've done is create a web
form that's going to submit whatever the
text box value is to a route called SLG
greet by default because there's no HTTP
or htps or no domain name SLG greet is
going to be assumed to be not at
google.com but whatever my own serers
URL is so whatever my code spaces URL is
that's going to be the implicit prefix
this SLG greet is just the route so now
let's go back to VSS codes app.py file
how do I now Stitch this together well I
think we're good to go with index.html
if index. html's purpose in life is just
to spit out this form we're done with
one of my routes but if I want to have a
second route greet that actually spits
out some greeting to the user well let's
prepare that template too let me go
ahead and highlight all of this HTML let
me go back into my terminal window and
into my hello directory and then into my
templates directory and let me create
another template called greet HTML whose
purpose in life will not be to show a
form but to greet the user with hello so
and so so in this file I'm going to
paste all that same HTML but I'm going
to get rid of the form and essentially
revert to our previous version hello
comma and then using the ginger syntax
name so one template index.html is for
the form the second template now is for
the greeting of hello comma so and so
but otherwise these files notice are
almost the same except one has the form
one has just the hello so now let's
finish this up in app doop High let me
go down here after a couple of blank
lines stylistically let me do app. route
quote unquote SLG greet but I could call
this route anything I want I'm just
using a a reasonable verb then let's
define another function I could call the
function anything I want X Y or Z I'm
going to call it more reasonably greet
no arguments and then now is the code
where I want to render the template so I
do return render template greet HTML but
but I need to do one more
thing what else do I want to do if I
want greet HTML to have access to the
human's name just to
recap I think we solved this already but
I deleted it but what do I have to add
back
yeahh yeah so I got to pass in the
placeholder somehow so I can do this a
couple of different ways I I'm going to
keep it a little more elegant this time
I'm just going to put my name uh
argument there and I'm going to set it
equal to request. ar. get quote unquote
name comma world before I used a
separate variable but I only used it in
one place so that's not strictly
necessary so this is fine too but if
this gets a little overwhelming notice
that I can alternatively do this I can
create an actual variable called name
and then I can pass in an argument
called name with a value that is that
variable but again what's really the
point here it was kind of prettier all
on one line so these are the exact same
things I'm just trying to tighten things
up further here all right so what just
happened if I go back to my form this is
still index.html if I reload it nothing
has changed if I type in my name to this
form notice again the URL I'm currently
at this is Chrome hiding things it's
technically slash by default even though
many browsers are just hiding
unnecessary uh characters these days but
Watch What Happens now if I scroll over
here and I click greet on this new
form notice my URL my route changed to
SL greet question mark name equals David
and the body of the page at top left
says hello comma David so this is
exactly how google.com works and it's
how we implemented search. HTML last
time but instead of submitting the form
to Google via the form I'm submitting it
to myself my very own route so I'm
implementing my own backend for this
same front end all right any questions
just yet much less interesting than
Google certainly but we kind of have all
of the wiring
now any
questions no
all right so what can we do to further
uh tighten this up and adhere to some
conventions well let me propose that in
this version we solve one problem and
even if you've never done this sort of
thing before I dare say we have enough
weeks of cs-50 where if I show you
index.html again and greet HTML again
odds are to someone's mind there's a
opportunity for
improvement why is this web app super
simple though it is arguably poorly
designed at the
moment and the answer lies somewhere in
these two templates index.html and
greet.tolowercase
probably did necessarily for your
homepage why because when you have HTML
only maybe CSS and even JavaScript
that's all you can do is copy paste copy
paste and just make sure that you have
the same structure maybe you have the
same CSS file the same Javascript file
the same third party libraries but it
makes it very very annoying as you might
have realized already to just m make a
change that affects everything so
wouldn't it be nice to like factor out
all of this and all of this and just let
the body change so here too is something
that flask and really other equivalent
Frameworks let us do it allows us to
create what we're going to call
conventionally a layout instead so I'm
going to go ahead and do this I'm going
to copy one last time all of the same
HTML I'm going to go into uh my terminal
window and I'm going to create by
convention a file called layout. HTML
this is truly going to be a blueprint of
sorts and in layout. HTML I'm going to
paste all of that same code but I'm
going to use now some ginger syntax to
indicate that I don't want to plug in
just a variable like name here I want to
actually plug the contents of a whole
other file so instead of just using
curly braces two of them left and right
I have to use slightly different syntax
to say I want a whole block of HTML here
from some other file and the way to do
this even though the syntax is a little
non-obvious is you use open curly brace
percent sign block then you can call the
next word anything you want it just has
to be a special type of placeholder for
an actual file not for just a variable
I'm going to call it body only because
I'm in the body so I'm want a
placeholder to be the entire body and
then outside of this you then say in one
word no space end block so it looks kind
of stupid honestly and why do we have
yet more ugly syntax again just
different software developers in the
world are all choosing their own Syntax
for their own libraries so they all kind
of look different but are all kind of
similar in spirit and you just get used
to seeing the different syntax this now
is not nearly as pretty as the pair of
curly braces for variables but this is
how I can say plug the contents of an
entire file Here and Now what does this
let me do I can now go back into my
index.html file which at the moment
still looks like this but almost all of
this is copy paste the only lines that
are interesting and different are these
four lines here in the body so what I
can actually do now is I'm going to
highlight that and cut it and then I'm
going to highlight everything else and
just delete the entire file and I'm
going to use some of that same syntax
and say curly brace percent sign extends
quote unquote layout. HTML and then I
close my thought with a percent sign and
close curly brace so this syntax as you
might just be inferring is now saying
please extend whatever layout. HTML
looks like that's the original blueprint
the mold out of which I want to make
this web page and now here the syntax is
a little weird too but similar at least
from before I can now say the block the
body block that I want you to plug into
that layout is going to be everything
between these two tags which we already
saw earlier but in layout. HTML they're
sort of giving a placeholder in
index.html this is what I'm going to
plug in to those other placeholders as
well so I'm just going to give myself
some extra white space I'm going to
paste the HTML that was there if I want
to make clear what's going on I can
indent it although this has no no
functional impact but it just makes
clear that just like in HTML you can
open a ginger tag and close it but in
ginger here we have this here hey uh Hey
python here comes the body of this page
hey python that's it for the body of
this page and all of this stuff should
be plugged into this main parent layout
if you will so super ugly admittedly but
now at least things get way less
redundant because I'm going to do the
exact same thing over here in greet HTML
it looks like this but now I'm going to
do this extends layout. HTML also just
as before uh the body the uh the body
that I want to plug in is going to be
everything inside of these tags here and
this body is just going to be hello
comma name in curly braces like that so
again ugly syntax got really ugly fast
but it's really just following these
patterns now and we have two types of
placeholders two curly braces for
variables and now this kind of syntax
with the percent signs and the single
curly braces for like contents of actual
files and so now in this world or in the
world of a homepage if you were using
flask and python to make your personal
homepage with all of those various Pages
you would probably design one main
layout with all of your pretty logos and
colors and fonts and like what you want
the site to look like and then each of
your smaller Pages would now be
distilled into just these smaller
fragments and whether you're using
python or Java or Javas script or other
languages too all different programming
languages have popular Frameworks that
do things like this the idea is the same
across all of them all right let's see
if it works let's go back into the
browser let me go back to my slash route
there's that same form let me type in
David and type and click greet and
indeed I see hello comma David I see
that greet was automatically added to
the URL by the browser when I submitted
the form followed by the key value Pairs
and if I view the page source as I did
earlier you'll see that you have the
entirety of that layout with hello David
plugged in meanwhile if I go back to the
form and view this page Source you'll
see the exact same layout but with the
form tag plugged in and here's where you
can be a little less uh nitpicky with
styling okay yes this isn't technically
indented inside of the body but it was
relative to the original file so at this
point in the game you don't need to
worry about your outputed HTML looking
super pretty you want your source code
that the see to be pretty not the
browser this is not a stylistic
concern okay questions on these
capabilities then a
flask or problems that we've just solved
and why
yeah uh okay so if the files in question
are in different folders for instance if
I go back into my uh index page which
has the form um the routes here are
entirely dependent on what is an app.py
there's no notion of a folder when it
comes to implementing a web application
anymore they are more generically routes
however and we've not done this yet you
can put your static content your images
your video files your CSS files in a
folder called Static and there can be
subfolders therein and that would affect
what you use as your Source attributes
for images or your Source uh tags for
video or any of those kinds of assets
and we'll see that eventually in the
home in the uh the problem set next
other questions on what we've just done
here
yeah good question how do I how did I
ensure that the web app starts on the
form and then goes to the hello page so
whatever you decide your default index
route is like the implicit slash that is
what is going to be pulled up when a
user visits the domain name where your
website is hosted so if I go back over
here to app Pi because my slash route is
designed to return index.html that's
exactly why that response came back good
question all right so beyond this let's
consider now issues of privacy and we'll
touch on this too as we get to issues
like shopping carts and cookies if I
zoom in on the URL here even though the
URL itself is a little long and ugly and
cryptic but when I type in my name and
hit uh greet of course we keep seeing
name equals David in the URL in what
sense might this be bad
design or in what kinds of web apps
might you not want the name to show up
in the URL like that because this is
what Google does this is what my app
does
yeah yeah so if I'm logging in with a
username and password I I could imagine
that they show up in the URL after the
question mark where username equals
mailin and password equals 1 2 3 4 5 but
then all my you know like nosy siblings
need to do is go through through my
browser history and boom like it's right
there for them to copy paste so that
doesn't seem particularly uh secure or
if someone's walking past you in a cafe
they can just look at your url if it's
revealed by the browser and they see it
too so get is not necessarily the best
verb to use even though it's the default
when submitting forms typically when
you've got anything remotely sensitive
or anything large so be it a password or
credit card number or like an image or a
video that you're uploading to uh
Instagram or to YouTube or any such site
like that you don't want the data going
into the URL and thankfully there's
actually an easy way to fix this I can
go into my form which is currently in
index.html and I can just change the
method from get to post in lower case
here but the verb in the virtual
envelope we discussed last week would
itself be capital p o St now
unfortunately Watch What Happens here
let me go over to my original form by
going back to the Slash rout and I'm
reloading the page to make sure I get
the latest freshest HTML and just as a
um just to confirm here yep if I view
Source method is now post so let me go
ahead and type in David now and click
greet and before we saw hello David but
now I get method not allowed and this is
somewhat subtle but in the title of the
tab notice that it's a 405 error which
is not familiar probably almost all of
us have seen 404 file not found turns
out 405 a little more Arcane is the
method the HTTP verb is not allowed why
because by default my app.py only
currently supports get by default how do
I support post well I just need a little
bit more syntax so let me go back into
vs code here let me go into app.py now
and after changing the form I just need
to inform flask that you know what the
method I want this GRE route to use
should not be the default which is only
get I want it to use these methods and
it takes a second argument called
Methods the value of which is a list the
default of which is quote unquote get so
that's the default this has not made any
changes but if I want to support post
instead I can explicitly pass a list
with one string in it P instead and now
what does this mean we didn't talk about
this in any detail last week but inside
of this virtual envelope typically is
that line like get slash search Q equals
cat after the ex after the question mark
if you want to hide that kind of
information for privacy sake or because
you want to upload like an image which
just doesn't make sense to put in the
URL essentially the part of the story
would be well the computer looks deeper
inside of that virtual envelope and
anything submitted via post goes below
the htdp headers like deeper in that
envelope so they're still there they're
just not obviously visible uh for prying
eyes in the user's own browser so just
by making that change in the HTML
telling the browser to submit the data
via post and changing app.py to tell the
route to expect the data via post I can
now go back to my other tab let me go
back to the original page let me reload
just so I've got the latest HTML and
indeed view page Source it's still yep
it's still post but now when I type in
DAV ID and click greet now it works but
but but notice the Privacy implication
I'm at the SLG greet route but where's
my name it's not actually there it's
still went to the server but it's not in
your autocomplete or your history now
for privacy sake questions now on
post yeah oh No Just scratching all
right can you the programmer see this
well let me show you a couple of other
features of Chrome's uh Chrome and
Safari and other browsers as well I keep
going to view page source which just
shows you like a readon version of your
HTML but recall that last time I
actually right-clicked and went to
inspect or viewed developer tool tools
and this brings up a much fancier
version of the developer tools and under
elements here you see everything and
it's nice and pretty printed it's
hierarchical it collapses things into
these clickable triangles but it's the
exact same thing it's just more
interactive but notice what I can do
today is this if I go to the network tab
here and let me zoom out a little bit
let me go ahead and re uh load the form
here and type in David again and click
greet notice now in the network tab of
Chrome's developer tools I see a few
things as we saw before one I see that
the request method is post two I see
that the server automatically without me
writing any code for this returns 200
when it's successful but I can scroll
down down down down down and you'll see
that eventually after all these cookies
more on those later if I click on
payload the second tab next to headers
you can see as the developer what was
actually sent to the server so indeed
this is going to be super useful like
when doing problem set 9 maybe your
final projects if you want to see what's
going from browser to server you have
complete control over all of that
information even if you're using htps
because your browser and you the
developer can certainly see all of this
so again these developer tools even
though there's a lot of tabs and buttons
you probably won't need anytime soon
some of them like elements and network
and with JavaScript console are going to
be super useful to start to get familiar
with all right any questions now on this
implication of
post anything at
all no okay how about one final hello
example that ties a few of these things
together how about now we try to tighten
things up further only in anticipation
of something like problem set 9 or
really more complicated web apps where
you might have not two but 20 or maybe
even more different routes it might
might be ideal to just minimize how many
total routes we have so we don't get a
little too overwhelmed and I dare say
that these two routes are so short maybe
I can combine them into one and maybe I
can keep the user at what seems to be
the same URL but just a kind of Tidy
things up so let me propose that we do
this instead let me get rid of my greet
route and let me go into my form in
index.html and let me go ahead and just
have the action of this form still slash
so I want the form to be visible at
slash the index of the site but I also
want the form to submit to itself if
only because I don't want to introduce
another route like SLG greet which
eventually indeed will be compelling so
you don't have one route for everything
you want your website to do so
technically this is the default to and
if I omit action the exact same thing
would happen as well but let me rewind
and let me now go into app.py to see how
we can make this happen well if I want
my one and now only route to support
both methods I can say methods equals
and then a list with both get and post
in any order but I'll keep them
alphabetical like this this now tells
python hey this route should handle both
get and post requests at the same place
let's now go into this function I kind
of want to say the equivalent of this if
get then I want to return the form else
if post I want to then return render
template of greet Doh HTML with the
user's name but this is not yet complete
code but I think I can do this I'm going
to go ahead and say the following I'm
going to go ahead and say if
request. method equals equals get then
indeed return
index.html L if request. method equals
equals post then go ahead and return
greet HTML this isn't quite enough
though because I still want to pass in
that placeholder so let me again add
back name equals request. args doget
quote unquote name and then a default
value of world what does this Now do for
me well let me go back to my other tab
here let me close the developer tools
let me go back to the form here let me
reload to make sure I have the latest
let me view page Source just to make
sure I have the latest and yep I have
the latest because it still says post
but it now says slash and let's see what
happens now if I type in my name David
previously this submitted bya post so I
didn't see any name or value thereof in
the URL but I did end up at SLG greet
but if the action is now slash and I
click greet notice that it still kind of
works I see hello comma World although
that didn't quite work so we'll come
back to that issue in a moment but
notice the URL ends in just slash and
again Chrome is hiding the slash because
that's all that's there but it does not
end in name equals David in this case or
name and equals world now notice this
too if I reload I'm going to get this
warning do you want to confirm form
resubmission the page you're looking for
used information that you entered
returning to that page might cause any
action you took to be repeated do you
want to continue you might have seen
this on websites you've actually visited
where you hit reload and you're prompted
wait a minute do you want to do that
odds are you've been prompted to reload
explicitly because why whatever you just
did was post instead of get and by
convention besides post being used for
privacy to like hide your username your
password your credit card number or the
like besides being used to upload bigger
files like images or videos post is also
used by convention to make changes to
the server to add something to your
shopping cart to add something to the
database whereas get is the name
suggests is all about getting
information not posting or sending
information instead so this is Chrome
being a little careful because you know
if you just checked out on Amazon and
then you hit reload you don't want to
accidentally like buy the same book
again so to speak even though Amazon and
fancy websites have other defenses for
this too to avoid this issue now there
is a bug though here it says hello comma
World instead of hello comma David and
it actually would have said the same a
moment ago and I just didn't retest the
code and reveal as much to you or if I
did I didn't even notice it said hello
world instead of hello David it turns
out that request. RGS is only used for
get when using get request. args is a
dictionary that contains all of your key
value pairs but somewhat confusingly
when using post with flask you have to
go into request. form I have no idea why
these are not sort of more obvious
opposites like request.get or request.
form and sorry request.get and request.
poost would be sort of sensible names in
this case though we have request. args
for get and request. form for post all
right that's an easy fix though if I go
back to vs code here let's change
request. ARS to request. form let's go
back to my other tab let me just reload
and you know what I'm going to say okay
continue to resubmit the same form
because the form was okay it was my
python code that was buggy hitting enter
now it's accessing David okay but watch
this again if I hit reload command r or
control r i get the same warning are you
sure you want to submit the form yes if
I do it manually with the reload icon I
get the same warning as before but if I
want to manually induce a get request
well that's fine don't hit reload and
send the same request instead go up to
your URL and just put the cursor up
there and hit enter and now notice same
URL is a get by default so anytime you
and I have typed URLs into browsers get
is always the default only when you
click on a button typically that the
programmer has configured to use post
are you actually adding things to your
shopping cart or the like all right so
we are back and if I go way back in time
myself like this is actually like the
first web application I made back in
1997 I believe uh so at the time this
was would have been what my sophomore or
so year I had taken cs50 I took a
follow- on class called cs51 which is a
different type of programming and then I
pretty much taught myself a language
called Pearl which is somewhat less
popular nowadays but it's another
language like python like Java like
JavaScript like others that can be used
to make web-based applications and the
web was very young at the time and the
process via which students my classmates
could register uh for the first year
intral sports program AKA Frost's was to
grab a piece of paper and like write
your name and email address on it and
walk it across across the yard to
Wigglesworth I believe where the Proctor
lived and you'd Slide the piece of paper
under the door and like that was how we
submitted forms in my day um so this was
an opportunity even back in 1997 is to
like move things online and the website
went on to live on until I think like
2007 I found this online and then it's
become something else since um but this
was a website via which people could
register for sports and people could log
in the scores for various games and
whatnot and so underneath the hood I
didn't even know anything anything about
databases at the time it was just like
CSV files that I was storing the data in
but there were HTML forms and there was
with pearl the language at the time the
way to do the exact kind of stuff that
we've just been doing already with flask
and so what I thought we'd do is
Implement a slightly less ugly version
of this um repeating uh graphical
backgrounds were invogue in like 1997 as
you can see here um but this is where
these were the Aesthetics of the day uh
including the the so-called blink tag so
let's at least focus on the
functionality of this website and not so
much the Aesthetics and see if we can't
Implement some of the plumbing for
actually solving like a real world
representative problem be it for
freshman inal sports or something else
like it where you're getting data from
users and processing it somehow so let
me go over here to VSS code let me
create a new directory called fros IMS
just so we can keep all of this code in
its own directory let me CD into fros
IMS let me proactively make another
directory called templates in which our
templates our HTML files do need to live
and eventually I'm going to go ahead and
create a two files minimally app.py and
index.html so let's do the first of
those app.py will live in my Frost im's
directory and I'm just going to recreate
something very simple like we have
previously so from flask in lowercase
import flask capitalized render template
and also request so same first line is
before let me then give myself a
variable called app set it equal to
calling the flask function capital f
with underscore uncore name underscore
uncore and then let me give myself a
route for slash as before with an index
function though again I could call that
anything I want and just for now let's
return render template of quote unquote
index.html as though that exists so this
is not really a web application as much
as it is at the moment just a recreation
of HTTP server for one file let's now in
another tab create a templates file uh
called called
index.html and I'm going to save myself
a few keystrokes I let me copy paste
from earlier almost all of the layout
from before I've change the title in
advance to frosts instead of hello but
this is essentially the same template
and for now though because I'm in an
index.html I'm not going to use extends
or any of that fancy block stuff yet I'm
just going to go ahead and create a
relatively simple form via which back in
the day my classmates could have
registered for interal Sports so let's
go ahead here and I'll propose that we
do this um in this page we'll have a
form the action of which will be a route
called SL register though I could call
that anything I want it'll be somewhat
private so I'm going to use post instead
of get just so that people don't
accidentally maybe register twice by
hitting reload uh without warning uh
inside of this form let's go ahead and
give them an input uh where autocomplete
will be off as always for demonstration
sake autofocus so the cursor goes there
initially the name of this field will be
literally named because I want my
classmates's name if they want to
register for some sport the placeholder
will again be quote unquote Nam just so
they see some gray instructions and the
type of this field will indeed be text
as before and then I need to give them
the ability to register for a few Sports
why don't we keep it simple like back in
the day basketball soccer and Ultimate
Frisbee were three of the sports that we
supported and so let me do this and you
might not have seen this before uh
unless you dabbled further on with forms
on your own but I can create a select
menu otherwise known as a drop-down menu
in HTML inside of which are a whole
bunch of options and each option
typically follows this Paradigm the
value of the option and then the actual
text that the human sees so the value of
these options will be how about we do uh
basketball as one and I want the human
to see literally the same thing though
just like with a link in HTML they could
be different but I'm going to keep them
the same another option will be
uh let's say
soccer and whoops let me fix my quotes
and this human will see the exact same
thing though it could say something else
and then lastly the value will be quote
unquote Ultimate Frisbee and the humans
will see the same thing there ultimate
frisbe all right so this is going to
create as we'll soon see just a drop-
down menu with three separate options if
I want the students to be able to submit
this now let me give them a button the
type of which is submit and this button
will be like the word register on it so
I think we're pretty much good to go
like this is all just HTML no python no
flask per se except for the rendering of
the same template so let me go into my
terminal window let me do flask run
inside of this directory because I need
to serve this app instead I'm going to
see some ugly output including my own
URL and if I hover over that and then
open that URL I should now see a more
interesting form it's got not only a
field for their name but also this
drop-down menu with all three Sports now
this isn't maybe the best user uh
experience thus far because I feel like
I'm biasing people to registering for
basketball maybe because it's checked by
default I mean a lot of forms nowadays
have like a blank placeholder for the
form so this is just an aesthetic thing
but I can do this let me go back to the
same form and let me give myself just a
a blank option at the top that in fact
I'm going to disable so you technically
can't select it proactively but I am
going to select it by default and so we
probably haven't seen those HTML
attributes before but if I want to
create the equivalent of like a a a
title for this dropdown I'm going to
literally create a disabled option
that's automatically selected called
sport so that you can't select it per se
but it is there at the top so if I go
back now to my other tab reload you know
it's just marginally prettier than
before and I'm not biasing people toward
accidentally registering for basketball
alone and if I click on this you'll see
that sport is great out and therefore
not manually selectable but I can select
any of these other three still all right
well un unfortunately if I type in David
and I try registering for instance for
soccer and click register I do end up
atreg and there's no question mark or
name or sport so it's probably indeed
post instead of get those are hints but
not found notice the tab here very uh uh
uh succinctly says 404 not found well
why is that just to be clear why did SL
register give me a
404 what's the logic
here perhaps just State the obvious
or it doesn't exist right we haven't
done that step yet all right so
something as simple as that and so I
actually U sort of belabor that point
because as you're learning like a lot of
these conventions and some of this new
syntax like honestly you're just going
to make stupid mistakes something's not
going to work but again go back to First
principles why is it not found all
right/ register should be a template
maybe called register. HTML oh I forgot
my app. route so that should be the kind
of of thinking as you try to diagnose
these problems moving forward all right
so let me go into app. and let me give
myself a second route here uh so app.
route quote unquote SL route then let me
Define a function called anything I want
but I'm going to call it oh sorry not SL
route SL register let me call the
function just to be consistent register
so but I could call that anything I want
and just for now let's not do anything
too interesting let's just return the
rendering of a template called success
.html let's just pretend for now that
registration is successful no matter who
you are or what you do now I need that
template and I only have index.html at
this point so let me actually now do my
best practices let me copy all of that
let me in a separate terminal window let
me do code uh let me go into my Frost
im's directory and let me create a new
template called layout. HTML just like
before let me paste all that same code
let me delete the form and just put in
that big placehold folder so block body
and then end block is all I did earlier
this is just kind of boiler plate now
convention everything else I'm going to
leave the same but if I wanted to make
it prettier I could add my CSS up top if
I wanted to add like this crazy
repeating background I could probably do
that up top too so I could make every
page look as ugly as it did back in my
day but we'll focus just today on the
text all right so now that I have
layout. HTML let me clean up index.html
I don't need all this redundancy I don't
need all of these tags at the top
instead recall I think I just need
extends quote unquote layout. HTML with
the appropriate percent signs and curly
braces I then have the appropriate block
body though I could call Body anything I
want but I'm going to stick with my
convention earlier and I'm going to
delete the tags down here that I no
longer need why because if I go into
layout. HTML I already have all my open
tags all my Clos tags the only stuff I
want in index.html is is going to be
which belongs in the body so end block
down here and just to be pedantic let me
go ahead and highlight all that hit
shift Tab and that will like unindent it
just to line things up just to be tidy
all right so better even though it looks
a little cryptic now but now I've laid
the foundation for making a third page a
fourth page that don't have all of that
same copy paste all right so now let's
go back into app.py success. HTML is
where I left off so okay let me open my
terminal window let me code up a
template called success. HTML whose
purpose in life is literally just going
to be like to say you are registered
just so that we see some informative
message on the screen so this part I do
still need extends layout. HTML so
there's a little bit of copy paste still
which is a little ugly but so be it
block body for this template and I'm
just going to say you are registered
exclamation point all right and then end
block so super simple it's just an
informative message claiming that the
Stu the student is registered all right
let's go back to the original form which
is this let me reload to make sure my
HTML has reloaded type in David I'm
going to register again for soccer and
click register and oh interesting method
not allowed so I'm not getting a 404
anymore I'm getting
405 at SL
register what's the deduction here how
did I screw up this
time 405 is progress yeah the
placeholder uh so it's not the
placeholder I think is okay this is now
about the underlying HTTP stuff the
method was disallow was not
allowed say again so get purposes post
thing too so by default all of these
routes in flask just by default assume
get because it's safe it doesn't allow
you to send information to the server in
quite the same way but if I do want to
support post recall that we changed this
to be methods equals and then a list
with quote quote Post in it so I just
need to enable support for that method
that that is that HTTP verb all right
let's go back to the form reload just to
make sure I haven't screwed up type in
my name David select soccer from the
dropdown click register and now I'm not
only at SL register in the URL it claims
that I am indeed registered now of
course I'm not I've done nothing
interesting there's no database there's
no CSV file we'll get to that in a bit
but at least I now have the plumbing in
place to do something Dynamic based on
that sport all right well how can I now
improve upon this how about we go ahead
and implement store the actual
registrant in a dictionary in the
computer's memory so instead of just
claiming that they're registered let's
actually make a notation and the
simplest way as we did weeks ago in
Python is just store things in like a
variable in memory like a list or a
dictionary a set anything like that all
right well let me go back into vs code
and in app.py and I think what I'm going
to have to do here is change my register
route to actually do some useful
information but before I register the
user let's consider where I want to
actually put them and so let me propose
that how about we do this at the top of
my file let me go ahead and declare a
global variable called registrant uh and
set that equal to an empty dictionary so
we've done this before when we were
playing around previously with using
dictionaries to store key value Pairs
and I'm going to propose that we store
the registrant as a dictionary why cuz
I'm going to keep it simple like the
name is going to be the student's name
sorry the key is going to be the
student's name and the value is going to
be whatever sport they registered for so
David and soccer and Carter and
basketball and so it kind of makes sense
for like a two column dictionary so to
speak as we often depict it on screen so
how can I use this dictionary well let
me go ahead and do this down here under
SL register let me go ahead and
initially do this how about we get the
user's name from request. form. Get and
set it equal to whatever the value of
name is and I'm not going to give a
default value now because I don't want
to call the student world or something
strange like that I'm just going to
assume for now that it's there let's
then create another variable called
Sport and do request. form doget quote
unquote sport to get these students
Sport and then let's go ahead and do
this in the
registrant dictionary let's index into
it using the student's name and let's
set it equal to whatever the sport is so
I've got these variables just to keep my
code tidy and I'm now putting a key
value pair in that uh into that
dictionary all right well what do I want
to now do and I'll I'll go ahead and say
success. HTML sure let's go ahead and do
that but now I think success. HTML means
that so let me go back to the form
reload let me type in David and soccer
register okay let me go back and say
Carter and basketball registered okay
now let's see what I want to do next how
about I go
into um Let me give myself another route
and let's play around here so app. route
let's give myself another third route
called registrant whose purpose in life
is just to show me who all of those
registrants are just like you would
expect from a website like this and then
let me Define a function called
registrants or anything else and then
let me return the rendering of a
template called
registrant H ML and let me pass in this
is kind of neat I can do registrant
equals registrant which again looks
weird but what am I doing I'm presuming
to pass in a placeholder called
registrant the value of which is this
dictionary that I've been collecting all
of the registrations in so similar to
the name placeholder before but it's a
little more powerful because now it's a
whole dictionary not just a single
string so I think now let me be creative
here let me go into my
templates under uh my templates folder
and let's do this uh let's go into uh my
terminal window let's create another
template called registrant HTML that's
actually going to do this displaying of
all of the registrant for us so extends
layout. HTML just so I can borrow all of
the same HTML as
before and let's define block body just
like before and inside of this and block
I want to put I don't know like a
bulleted list or an ordered list list of
all of the registrant so how can I do
this well let's do uh an unordered list
ul and here's where Ginger and flask
more generally get kind of interesting
like I want there to be something like
this An
Li uh and then like the students's name
and then an L uh maybe Li yeah like that
and then maybe like sport something like
this but I didn't pass in a name I
didn't pass in a sport I passed in the
entire dictionary of registrants now in
Python if we were just doing something
at the black and white terminal window
and doing a command line program you
know I'd probably have some kind of for
Loop in Python Ginger does allow you to
do this so a templating language tends
to come with very lightweight mechanisms
for doing placeholders doing Simple
Loops doing Simple conditions so python
like syntax and it's almost identical so
watch what I can do inside of this
unordered list let me not start to
manually output a single Li let me use
this syntax the same Ginger syntax that
I used for Block so curly brace percent
sign and I'm going to say this for name
in registrant so this is just like
python Syntax for iterating over a
dictionary and now this is going to look
stupid but the opposite of that is end4
so in HTML you use the slash in ginger
you literally use the word end no space
and then the name of the keyword so end4
is how you close this but this is where
templating gets really cool you can now
do Li and in here I can do something
like that student's name and that's it
I'm going to leave it like that and what
I'm doing here is using really a
template as templates are intended I've
got like the basic building blocks of
what I want this output to look like but
thanks to this little for Loop here
thanks to Ginger syntax the curly brace
and the percent sign I'm going to
iterate over every dictionary printing
out name name name name and so if I've
got two kids registered now I'm going to
see two liis David and Carter
respectively so let's see let me go back
to uh my Frost IM tab here and I don't
have a link yet so I got to do this
manually uh like a developer would let
me go to slash registrant and I'll zoom
out and hit
enter and you'll see what you'll
probably see two when making mistakes
for the first time in this world so
where is the error message unfortunately
internal Ser server error is not all
that useful but we do tell you you see
terminal window so if I go to the
terminal window I haven't been paying
attention to this for quite some time
and in fact I have two terminal windows
open so that I can still use commands at
the prompt but if I go back to my first
terminal window AKA bash there you'll
see in your terminal window When
developing web applications like all of
the mistakes you made in the terminal
itself this is one of those python
tracebacks that's related to me screwing
up here now let me go ahead here and
let's see uh type error function is not
iterable
and block for name function is not
iterable all right so what mistake did I
make well this is what happens when I
don't follow my notes and make changes
on the fly so I have this variable on
line five called registrant in all lower
case but what did I then do on the Fly
here in line
22 I defined a function called
registrant so like newbie mistake like I
shouldn't have done this I can't have a
variable and a function of the same name
name because the symbols are literally
identical so just to make clear that
this variable up here is actually Global
we'll use our convention like we did in
C often when we had a global variable
we'll capitalize it all just to make it
stand out like a a constant value up
there and so down here what I'm going to
do is pass in registrants in all cap so
that was stupid didn't mean to confuse
there but the reason for that error to
be clear is that you can't have a
function that's the same name as a
variable I could just change the
variable name alt together I'm going to
go ahead and just capitalize it to make
it really stand out that this is in fact
a global variable up top all right now
I'm going to go back to my browser let's
do David and
socer all right but there's going to be
some other mistakes here so on line 17
let me go ahead and change this variable
to be capitalized there because indeed I
want to put the key and the value in
this newly named variable as all
capitals registrant let me now go back
to vs code here let me go back to the
form and let me start adding some data
fresh let me register David for soccer
clicking register now and we should see
you are registered but hopefully now
it's indeed in the computer's memory let
me go back and register now Carter for
basketball clicking register again and
hopefully it's now registered if I now
change my route manually to B SL
registrant which is this newly added
route that I made and hit enter now I
see thank God now I see the unordered
list containing everything in the
computer's memory so when I say you are
registered I kind of mean it now because
the server is still running and in the
computer's memory is in this registrant
Global variable a dictionary of key
value pairs of course we're only seeing
the keys at the moment so it might be
nice to actually see the values in as
well so let me go back to VSS code and
let me go into registr trans. HTML and
I'll just do something a little messy
I'll just say uh how about let just make
it a sentence is registered
four and now another placeholder I'm
going to say registrant bracket name so
just like in Python if registr is itself
a dictionary registr bracket and then
the key you want to index into is
perfectly valid syntax as well so now
let me go back to SL registrant let me
click reload again so why isn't it
working everyone what's the bug that I
introduced earlier if David is
registered for none and Carter is
registered for none but David and Carter
are in the dictionary like that's a good
thing so some of the data is in there so
why are there no Sports Associated well
the first thing I literally just did in
front of you all was I went to app.py
and I stared at line 17 thinking like
how did I screw this up I'm putting
sport as the value of the key which is
the student's name all right line 17
looked fine to me a few seconds ago so I
looked then with my eyes at line 16 and
this too looked okay my first thought
was oh did I use request. args instead
of request. form instead because that
would have assumed get instead of post
but no like that looks okay too so then
my final Instinct was oh my god did I
screw up the HTML form and so that's why
I went back over to my tab here I went
to the original form here I then view
page source and this might not be as
obvious to you if you've never seen the
select menu before what is apparently
missing here that might explain my
mistake yeah
yeah I didn't name this form field quote
unquote sport now to be fair you haven't
seen me do this as a select menu before
and it's different from this input when
you have an input tag you literally say
name equals whatever on the input tag it
turns out I don't know why I skipped
this earlier I probably meant to come
back to it the select tag also can take
a name parameter so if I go back to the
name
parameter here and go back and add the
name parameter let me go into that
template which is
index.html let me add name equals quote
unquote sport in all lowercase which is
different from the visual aesthetic of
this temporary disabled option that's
just there to make things prettier for
the human now let me go ahead here and
first I'm going to go into my terminal
window and I'm actually going to hit
control C to stop the server alt
together because I want to throw away
the contents of memory and therefore get
rid of that dictionary that had David
and Carter and those nun values so this
is sort of me clearing the computer's
memory I'm going to rerun flask run I
get that same URL as before so I'm going
to hover over that and open the new tab
and just to be sure I'm going to do view
page source and here I see now okay now
the form has both a name and a sport in
it all right now I'm really going to
cross my fingers because I intend for
this now to work David will register
again for soccer register claims we are
registered I'm going to go back and do
it again for Carter and basketball
register we still don't have a link so
I'm going to manually go up to the URL
and change/ register to registrant as
before zooming out and hit enter and
thank God now I'm actually registered
properly for this so oh thank
you so what is it like 20 years later
I'm still struggling to implement this
site okay so um so here now we have for
the first time in Python and web stuff
like now we have a proper web
application and it's not just echoing
back hello David hello Carter this could
now work for any of you and it's
currently served privately but if I made
this URL public I could put this on the
web now and let anyone in the world
register but there's kind of some issues
here there's some security flaws
potentially and so for instance let me
go back to the web form here and let me
open up the inspect tab the developer
tools and just remind you that anyone on
the internet not only you the developer
but a an adversary can see all of your
HTML see all of your CSS see all of your
JavaScript but more importantly because
this is all client side in the browser
there is literally nothing technically
stopping them from changing the HTML or
at least their copy of it and I did that
last week with Yale I changed their
website but no I changed my copy of
their website but when forms get
involved you could maybe be actually
malicious now because even though this
drop-down menu only has basketball
soccer and Ultimate Frisbee suppose I
really want to register for how about uh
let's say uh name your favorite sport
volleyball we really want to register
for volleyball but like this website
won't let me well there's nothing
stopping me from going under the
elements tab in my browser going into
this select menu here and you know what
no one ultimate for me let's change this
to volleyball and let's change this to
volleyball enter I'm going to close the
inspector now and as requested now we
support volleyball in the form now now
it's not changed on the server to be
fair but think about how HTTP works when
I fill out this with uh say let's see
Bernie's name Bernie really wants to
register for volleyball as well at the
moment my code is just going to trust
that what's in request. form is what was
in the original form itself no matter
whether the human adversarially actually
changed it so if I actually submit this
form and click register for Bernie and
volleyball even though that's not one of
the supported available Sports if I now
go to registrant my website nonetheless
has trusted that uh Bernie and perhaps
you are registered for volleyball so
what's the implication of this this has
surely happened in the past when like
really poorly implemented websites um
allow you to uh specify the price of an
item for instance in your shopping cart
and they just trust that when you click
submit or add to cart it adds the price
to the backend server if you're not
validating the price and making sure as
with a database that wait a minute that
price is valid valid or wait a minute
those sports are valid like who knows
what people are going to do to your site
and it's that simple to actually hack a
website accordingly now we can very
easily fix this with some um some week
six style python we really just need to
do a bit of logic here and so let me
propose this let me go into app.py here
and at the very top let me also create
how about a uh Global variable called
Sports in all caps and I'm going to set
that equal to in square brackets the
list of Sports I actually want to
support so I'm going to put in
basketball here I'm going to put in
soccer here and I'm sorry no volleyball
officially I'm going to put in ultimate
frisbee here so I've got this Global
list of supported Sports now think about
how I made this form a while ago I just
hardcoded these Sports here well I don't
have to do that I can sort of draw upon
my own official list of sports instead
so let me scroll down to my
index.html rendering template here let
me say that the sports I want to support
are are these so just using the same
placeholder trick as before but I'm now
telling the template what sports we
currently support now if I go back into
index.html I don't have to manually do
any of this let me get rid of all three
of those options which I manually
inputed earlier let me use my new trick
with ginger syntax and say for sport in
sports then let me proactively say end
for just to finish that thought and then
in here let me do option value equals in
curly BRAC is Sport and then so that the
human also sees the same words I'm going
to say sport out here so I've completely
changed what was hardcoded manually
typed to something now that's completely
Dynamic so now it's not going to stop
someone adversar like me from changing
the HTML but watch this the behavior on
the form if we go back is still now the
same drop down as before so
aesthetically it looks the same but you
know what why don't we be clever now and
let's go into app.py and the/ register
route and why don't we say this uh if
how about sport not in sports then let's
return render template uh failure. HTML
now this template doesn't exist yet so
let me just quickly make this real fast
I'm going to copy that code from before
let me create a code file in uh failure.
HTML I'm just going to paste this here
so I have a super simple error message
and I'm going to say you are not
registered just to that's what we mean
by failure and now in app.py consider
what logic I've added Sports in all caps
on line 22 is that same Global list as
before by asking pythonic if sport not
in sports well then you hacked me like
you tried to inject volleyball or some
other sport into request. form so I'm
just going to say no failure not letting
you register and I can do this a little
more uh verbosely too why don't I also
say this if if not name so if the name
is blank let's similarly return a render
template of failure. HTML in other words
if you didn't give me a name you left it
blank that's not useful for me running
the sports program let's also consider
that to be a failure so if I go back to
this tab now I'm going to reload just to
make sure I have the latest client side
let me be lazy and just click register
enter you are not registered because I
didn't give it an actual name all right
well let's go back how about I now type
David but no no I'm not going to choose
a sport I just want register myself nope
that did not work now let me go ahead
here and choose soccer this I think does
work let me go back now and try this
hacker trick whereby I go into the drop-
down menu I go into the select menu I
change as before Ultimate Frisbee to
volleyball and I'll change this one here
to
volleyball let me close the tab now this
looks like it's available now but when I
click register this this time it says
you are not registered and this is much
better than relying on other techniques
you might see or have seen online with
regard to HTML because there's also this
trick let me go back to the screen here
let me go back to index.html and you
might have seen online or you might
eventually see online that there's other
attributes you can use like required you
can literally tell the browser uhuh this
field is required you cannot leave it
blank if I go back to the browser now
reload and I again presume to be lazy
and I don't type in any name and click
register okay so that's kind of nice
like now the browser is being a little
more helpful for me saying no no no this
is required you have to fill this out
but again if you know what you're doing
okay well I disagree with your requiring
a name of me let me go in here let me go
over to this tag let me delete the
required attribute and now I slip
through but I didn't slip through on the
server and so there's a difference here
and an important distinction and so many
people in the real world still screw
this up there's client side validation
like actually checking that the data is
as you expect on the client side the
browser and there server side validation
and even though client side validation
like adding that required attribute
makes things more user friendly right
like that was a pretty little popup it
tells me that it's required it just
looks better than the previous version
it is not trustable you cannot trust any
input that ever comes from the user
because clearly with like a an hour or
so of cs50 like they can learn how to
turn all of these defenses off so even
if you like the user interface better
client side you have to have to have to
do server side validation always users
are not to be trusted and as soon as any
app or website you make becomes popular
unfortunately then you have to deal with
all of the adversarial possibilities as
well oh good question could the
adversary potentially access things
sensitive like app.py theoretically no
like if flask itself is buggy then sure
maybe if you're running some other
software on your server on your laptop
then sure uh it it's possible however if
your server is properly configured
theoretically they should not be able to
get access to that with that said we'll
soon see or You might with your final
project if you do something web based
you're never going to want to write like
usernames and passwords in your actual
code you can put them in what are called
environment variables so sort of in the
computer's memory but not in your code
just in case you or someone screws up
there are uh still ways to defend
against those kinds of possibilities
however slim
yeah a good question and this comes back
to First principles just like in C and
in python as soon as you return from a
function that's it nothing below that
line of code executes and so to
summarize the question even though I'm
returning this failure. HTML template
how am I making sure we still don't
accidentally put volleyball in that
Global dictionary it's because for
instance if you don't give me a name on
line 22 at the moment I'm returning the
failure template and that's it lines 23
24 25 26 27 never execute in particular
26 never executes and that's where I
would have been saving the name
similarly if we do we get a invalid
sport that is either blank or not in the
original authoritative list we return
failure. HTML is a template in line 25
we never get to line 26 so it just boils
down to return and what that means in
Python 2 good question other questions
as
well no all right how about we make one
more enhancement here or so because the
problem with storing everything in this
Global dictionary might be what we've
got it all working finally but why is
probably a global dictionary not the
place to store Frost's registration
data what's the implication of
this okay might slow the whole process
down but that actually Ram is actually
good memory is actually generally a good
thing so not going to be a deal breaker
here why might I not want to store that
data though in that
variable you can perhaps infer how I fix
something
earlier yeah and
back yeah it gets it's the memory gets
deleted garbage collected if you will as
soon as flask stops running so if you so
much as hit control C like you've just
lost all of your freshmen who registered
for the sport probably not a good thing
I did this deliberately a moment ago and
I hit control C because I did want to
clear the dictionary but trusting that
your server will never crash and your
code will always work and the power will
never go out like that's not the right
way to build any kind of web application
with persistent data so what we probably
want to do is reintroduce csvs and we've
played with those in C and in Python
could totally use csvs but we also now
have p uh SQL at our disposal and let me
propose that we do this in SQL in
instead and for this let me go ahead and
open up a version of the program that I
wrote in advance so let me go ahead and
close these templates which will look
very similar but a little different from
the ones I wrote in advance and let me
go ahead and open up uh in today's let
me go into Source 9 let me go into Frost
im's how about version four technically
in the versions online and let me go
ahead and open up app.py as follows so
here is an already made version that
does just a little something different
at the very top I'm importing cs50 SQL
Library which you might recall we used a
couple of weeks past just to write
python that talks to a SQL database and
this feels like an opportune moment to
bring that idea back down here on line
eight I'm creating a DB variable that
opens up a file called frost. DB using
syntax that we've seen before I did
create this FRS DB file in advance of
class just so that we have a couple of
columns in which to store names and
sports and such here's that same Global
array a global list called Sports and
let's just see what's going on down
below if I scroll down to Index this is
the same as before as we wrote together
on the Fly let's skip deregister for a
moment and go now into register so this
one's a little different but let's see
what I've done I've got some comments in
here because I wrote it in advance and I
think this logic is pretty much the same
though I tightened it up and I'm asking
two questions at once using on line 38
the or keyword here just to say if
there's not a name or the sport is not
in sports that is what we'll call now a
failure but what's fun now is that on
line 42
I'm using the cs50 SQL library to
execute some actual SQL and I'm going to
insert into a table called registrant
two columns name and Sport what names
and Sport well these two values with
placeholders plugging in name and Sport
notice I'm using the question marks
absolutely necessary so we don't get one
of those SQL injection attacks because
that too could be possible if someone
typed in some dangerous words or
keywords like delete or single quotes or
semicolons in the form here I'm letting
the library sanitize the data and then
this is a trick we haven't yet seen and
it's really going to start tying things
together I can also use a redirect
function in flask that has the effect of
doing the the if you will uh
safetyschool.org trick again whereby
after the user registers if I want to
automatically show them now everyone who
is registered atreg I don't have to
manually expect that they'll change the
url like I've been doing for the past
few minutes I can just redirect them
anywhere I want on my app or heck I
could redirect them to any URL on the
internet using this function call and
it's just a nice way to send them to a
different route if you want them to see
in this case those registrant so let me
do this in the same directory let me
increase my terminal window size let me
do SQL light three of frost. DB and let
me type schema and you can indeed see it
wraps on to two lines here that each
registrant has an ID which will be
automatically assigned one two three on
up a name which is not null text and a
sport which is also the same and the
primary key is just going to be this
unique identifier so that I made in
advance but if I do select star from
registrant semicolon there's no one
currently registered for any sports but
let's try now running this let me go
ahead and close my old version which we
wrote together and I'll close that tab
let me do flask run in this version four
here all right I'm going to see some
similar output I'm going to open the URL
now and you'll see that I made a couple
of Chang changes before instead of using
a select menu I used what are called
radio buttons now which is a reference
to Old School radio buttons that were
mutually exclusive in cars back in the
day and we'll see how to do this but
it's just an alternative to a select
menu and I'm going to go ahead and type
in my name again here so I'll do David
I'll do soccer by selecting this radio
button and I'm going to click register
now and notice what happened it's a
little ugly the formatting but so again
was this 20 years ago here I have now
now at the slash registrant route
instead of an unordered list I'm just
using a simple HTML table so I'll show
you what this looks like in just a
moment too and I'll show you this
deregister button which is sort of
unnecessarily large I also have
functionality we'll soon see for how you
can unregister someone from a sport as
well so take your name out of contention
well let me go back to my terminal
window here and I'm going to click the
plus to give myself s a second terminal
so I can go back into Source 9 Frost IMS
4 I'm going to do SQL light of frost. DB
I'm going to do select star from
registrant now and now you'll see that
indeed there's David registered for
soccer and in fact if I quit the flask
program with control C and rerun it
again no big deal because that next
version of flask will just use the
database as well so I'm persisting
keeping the data in SQL light whereas
I'm actually grabbing it using my python
code in flask all right let's put one
more person in here so we can delete one
of us too Carter for basketball register
and now we see both of us here all right
so let's see how we did this let's go
back over to VSS code let me shrink down
my terminal window let me go into the
actually let's go into the templates
directory and let's look at for instance
index.html so previously we were using a
select menu turns out radio buttons use
the input tag but instead of having
input of uh type equals text like for
the human's name you have type equals
radio and so long as each of your radio
buttons has the same name the same name
the same name that's what makes them
mutually exclusive so checking one radio
button turns off the others because they
have the same name the value I want to
assign to each of these radio buttons is
just the sport placeholder this is what
the human sees on the screen so it's
almost the same as the select menu it
just looks aesthetically different but
there's my same button so that's all the
difference I made there and I added a
heading tag H1 just to say register to
make clear what it is but let's take a
look at another file uh this one now
being how about the SL registrant route
so if I open up registr trans. HTML here
now it's way more verbose than my
unordered list but this is just kind of
boring HTML here's my table tag table
head table row table heading this makes
things bold as the first row of the
table name sport are my two columns I've
got a third empty column just so I can
fit that button as we'll soon see again
T body for table body here's the same
for Loop trick again so that I can
output for every registrant a whole
table row and there's this weird form in
there but we'll come back to that but
there's the registrant's name there's
the registrant sport but notice the
slightly different syntax here recall
that cs50's select uh cs50's execute
function when it returns to you a list
of dictionaries you can then get at the
individual columns by way of those keys
so let's go to the/ registrant Route let
me go back to app.py scroll down here
and it's actually super simple here I
have a SL registr route that first
executes select star from registrant so
just old SQL stuff give me everyone from
the registr table let me then render the
template called registr trans. HTML and
just pass in this list of dictionaries
and we haven't quite done this yet but
if you go back to register. HTML how do
you iterate over each dictionary in that
list well the syntax is just for
registrant in registrants that makes
this a dictionary one at a time in the
list just like in Python so registrant
name and registrants sport is just
another Syntax for using the square
bracket notation it's just a little
cleaner and slightly more succinct than
having quotes and square brackets
everywhere and then the rest of this is
just
HTML so what happens now if I want to uh
like Carter has been cut from the
basketball team if you will so how do we
do that well we want to click this
button deregister next to Carter's name
but how does this work and think about
now any website you visited that has
something like a shopping cart uh where
you can remove things from your cart or
update quantities or add more quantities
to your shopping cart on Amazon or
anything else well let's actually look
at the HTML that my app has spit out
let's actually look at this here and
we'll see the following we'll see that
we have here in the HTML that reached
the user not only is David in the first
column socer in the second notice that
my register. HTML form is also spitting
out a tiny little web form of its own
it's ugly but I only care about its
functionality for now and notice what
I'm doing here every registrant in this
database gets their very own deregister
button and that form has a button that
says deregister but notice what else
each of those forms have there's no text
box there's no drop down menu there's no
radio buttons rather you have a hidden
input field here so there is a way with
HTML to have a form that will submit
information but you don't have to give
the user the ability to change that
information you can just go ahead and
tuck it inside of the form invisibly if
you will hidden in fashion and so what's
going to happen is if I click the D
register button next to Carter his
primary key is two
mine is instead one so what's going to
happen if I click his deregister button
it submits a form with a
ID parameter whose value is two and it
submits it to the deregister route so
what do that mean well if I go to VSS
code and I go to app.py let's look at
the deregister route that I skipped over
so if you access the deregister route
via post this code gets called I grab
from request form the ID that was
submitted in Hidden fashion if there's
indeed an ID that is it's not blank it's
not zero it's an actual number like one
2 three or more I execute delete from
registrant where ID equals that value
with a question mark Place holder and
then I redirect the user back to
registrant now if I go back to this form
here I click deregister we'll see that
in action gone is now Carter and in fact
if I go back to my terminal window here
I open open up uh SQL light 3 of frost.
DB and rerun select star from registrant
Carter is now gone so again using very
simple HTML forms you can get buttons
and links and other such UI mechanisms
to like do things on the server that you
want but there is a danger here this now
is really meant this example is like an
administrative website like it was some
20 years ago just for us internal staff
to be doing things technically this is
dangerous what I've just done
two even though Carter's ID is two and
hidden and mine is one in Hidden what
could this allow an adversary to do if
they had admin access to the same
site any
thoughts
yeah
yeah yeah they could change the value of
that hidden attri by opening up chrom's
like developer tools change the number
in the HTML they could delete anyone
deregister anyone want from the database
now in this case I claim this is fine
because this is only meant for us staff
who were running Sports back in the day
but it's indeed a risk so wouldn't it be
nice if we could actually ensure that
only those users who are authorized are
allowed to execute certain actions I
think for this capability we're actually
going to need to introduce something a
bit more and so here of course is an
opportunity to talk briefly about really
what you and I do all day long every day
we log into one or more websites or apps
or at least until uh you're logged out
automatically and you have to do it
again so here for instance is a
screenshot of Gmail when you type in
your username you type in your password
maybe your to factor code that gets
texted or sent to your phone then you're
logged in and thankfully you're not
prompted to log in again typically for
number of hours or days or weeks
depending on the website like Gmail
keeps you logged in for ages your bank
probably logs you out within an hour or
so for safety sake so that is completely
configurable on the server but how does
g Emil know how does Google know that
even as you're checking different mails
again and again and again how do they
know that you're still the same person
who logged in well it turns out that
using these same building blocks as
today HTTP and HTML and more you can
actually implement the notion of a login
feature by doing the equivalent of
something with something called cookies
essentially what happens when you first
log into a website for the very first
time successfully with your username and
password a cookie so to speak is planted
on your computer and metaphorically this
is kind of like taking a hand stamp and
your hand is now stamped in this case a
smiley face so that every other time you
click on a link on that same website
google.com gmail.com whatever
unbeknownst to you your browser is
constantly presenting that handstamp
just like going into a club or an
amusement park or something like that
where they don't want to check your ID
again they don't want to check your
ticket again they just want to quickly
see the same hand stamp and so that is
one of the things that a browser is
always doing for you once you're logged
in any cookies that have been planted so
to speak in your Mac or PC or phone are
constantly represented to the site every
time you click a link or make another
request to that website and mechanically
how this works not just metaphorically
and ink essentially this is what happens
here is a example of an HTTP request to
something like Gmail and suppose for
instance that you've logged in typically
as of last week we said that coming back
from the server would be another virtual
envelope containing like a 200 okay
message and then like the actual web
page or the picture of a cat or whatever
it may be but Google can also if they
verified that you have some username and
password correctly inputed they can do
the equivalent of stamping your hand and
the way they do this is they send an
additional line of text in that virtual
envelope from the server to your browser
literally using another HTTP header not
content type which just mundanely tells
you what kind of content has come back
they literally send an http header
called set-cookie and then they set a
key value pair on your Mac or PC this is
the technical equivalent of this smiley
face handstamp and what your computer is
designed to do because your computer and
intern browser are supposed to implement
HTTP anytime you click another link on
Gmail or click on another mail or the
like your browser unbeknownst to you
presents that handstamp and how it does
it technically is in the envelope it
sends to Google from your browser it
doesn't send set cookie it just sends
cookie colon and the exact same thing
and so long as Google is smart and they
have a database or something of all of
the session Valu session is the
technical term for this maintenance of
information across HTTP so long as
Google has a big database that knows
that my cookie value is one 123 and your
cookie value is 456 they can infer from
this virtual handstamp whose emails they
should be showing mine or yours or the
like so this is just scratching the
surface but if I really wanted to enable
only Carter to deregister himself I just
have to make sure that I log him in
somehow username password and all of
that I stamp his hand or really put a
cookie on his computer and only if his
cookie lines up with the user ID he's
trying to deregister should he be
allowed to in fact do so so all of this
is quite possible and indeed the
technical term for this is session and
what we thought we'd do in our remaining
time Today show you some examples of
exactly how some of the most familiar
web functionality is implemented today
some of which you'll use in your own uh
problem set 9 uh which itself will be a
web app or perhaps even your final
project so let me go ahead and do this
let me close my previous tabs and all
things for ashs and let's move on to
implementing some notion of login so in
just a moment I'll switch over here to
VSS code and what I'm going to do is
indeed in my source 9 directory I'm
going to go into a login directory and
if I type LS here you'll see app.py
requirements. text which just refers to
libraries I want to automatically
install and a templates folder as well
I'm going to go ahead and stop the
previous server and close that terminal
window and I'm going to open up this
version of
app.py so there's a few new lines here
and we'll give you these lines for
problems at nine but I've got some of
the familiar stuff up here including
this new redirect function we just used
and I have a session variable that comes
with flask 2 so what's nice again about
flask is that it deals with all of this
cookie stuff for you it sets the cookie
it checks the cookie and what flask does
for you is it gives you the abstraction
of a variable called session so that
anything you put in the session variable
which itself is a dictionary will be
there again and again and again whenever
that same user comes back a session is
how you implement essentially like the
proverbial shopping cart uh if I'm
logged into Amazon you're logged into
Amazon Amazon knows which of us is which
by way of that cookie and Amazon if
they're using flask provides the
programmer with a dictionary called
session and flasks make sure that when
Carter is visiting the site the code
uses his session object when I'm
visiting the site it uses my session
object but it's all implemented with
those same cookies this is the same as
before these lines are new and you'll
see these in problem Set n this is how
we enable sessions in a web application
and I'll just wave my hands at the
detail there's different ways to
implement sessions whether you use
cookies on the server cookies on the
browser or other things these just
ensure that we're storing the the
session information the shopping cart on
the server itself now down here let's go
ahead and do this let's go ahead and run
flask run so I can see what this app
does if I do this and visit the URL that
gets outputed you'll see a very simple
web page here and if I type in for
instance my name I'm not going to bother
with a password and click log in you'll
see that you are logged in as David and
now I can log out so I'm going to go
ahead and click log out and now it seems
to know that I'm not logged in again I
can log in as Carter because I didn't
bother implementing passwords for
Simplicity but now the site knows I'm
logged in as Carter better yet if I
reload reload reload or click this
button again and again notice it still
knows that I'm Carter uh until such time
as I log out all right well how is this
working well let's go back to vs code
here and let me scroll down to first
this route this is a very common
Paradigm here whereby I'm checking for
the index route if there is not a name
in the session redirect the user to SL
login now what does that mean well let
me go back to vs code here let me go to
the slash route so again your url will
be different but I'm just going to go to
slash and hit enter notice that I got
automatically redirected to login and so
many websites do this if you go to a
website and you're not logged in you're
very often redirected to SL login or SL
account or something like that where
you're prompted the code for doing that
is right here if there's no name in the
session if there's no name in the
shopping cart if you will go ahead and
return the user to login that route
otherwise implicitly if they are logged
in show them index.html so let's go down
that rabbit hole let me open up in VSS
code a second terminal window let me go
into Source 9 and go into this same
login demonstration and let me open up
the template called
index.html and here's all this is
there's some layout but who cares at
this point it's just the boiler plate
generic HTML here's the body block I
have this and this two is ginger because
of the curly brace and the percent sign
if there's a name in the session this is
just python syntax then say this
sentence you are logged in as whatever
name is in the session in the shopping
cart if you will and then I just have
this HTML link for logging the user out
else if there is no name in the session
logically just say you are not logged in
and give them a manual link for logging
in instead so that's all this particular
template does but how does the slash
login work well let's go into this other
template code of login. HTML to which
I'm redirected super simple this is just
copy paste from HTML before I've got a
login form that's going to have an
action of Slash login submits for
privacy sake just via post and then the
rest of this is just a simple form and
I'm using using an input type equals
submit instead of button equals type
equals submit but same idea here too and
if I go back to app.py well let's see
how login works all right it's a lot all
at once but they're relatively simple
reapplications of the same idea so if
the user visits SL login via get or post
call this function login if the user has
submitted via post and we saw this
technique before go ahead and do this on
line 23 store in this special session
variable that comes with flask a name
key and store in it the user's own name
so quote unquote name will have a value
of David or Carter or the like and as
soon as you do that redirect the user
back to slash just so they see the
homepage again and this is how Amazon
and all these other websites work too
otherwise if they visit this page
implicitly via get and even though I
didn't say equals equals get anywhere
that's sort of the implication because
if you can only get here via get or post
and we already handled post logically
All That Remains is get well then just
show them the login screen instead but
there's half a dozen ways we could
express that same logic and then for log
out this is kind of straightforward if
the user clicks that log out link and
ends up at SL logout this route well
just change the value of that key in the
session to be none effectively no Carter
is gone David's gone there's no one
logged in so that is all that's required
to actually implement the notion of
logging in and logging out of website
plus the password thing which should
probably involve a database but one
thing at a time and really session is
sort of like the code version of a
shopping cart whereby if I visit the
same code I get my own session object if
Carter visits the website he gets his
own session object and the way flask
Keeps Us straight is they put one cookie
on my computer a different cookie on his
computer and uses those to line up with
making sure the right session gets shown
to the right actual
user questions on this notion of
sessions no all right how about a couple
final examples just to tie this all
together let me go back into vs code
here let me quit my previous version of
flask let's go into Source 9 and go into
store which is a separate app Al
together and let's start by just running
flask to see what it does let's hover
over the URL and open it in another Tab
and this is pretty ugly too let me zoom
in but it's a very simple bookstore like
an early amazon.com for each of these
seven books here Each of which seems to
be like maybe this is H1 this is H2 H2
H2 H2 and then there's a button
underneath each well now let's use this
as an opportunity to kind of infer like
for any website how this thing works let
me go ahead and do view page source and
you can do this for any website on the
internet let's try to figure out how
this bookstore adds things to a cart
well here's the H1 tag uninteresting H2
H2 H2 so the juicy part is in these
forms each of these forms has an action
of SL cart so that's the route that's
going to be interesting in a moment and
it uses post for privacy sake each of
these forms like the deregister feature
for Carter has an ID attribute an ID
parameter that's hidden visually that
has a value of one or two or three so
like the unique uh uh like barcodes for
the books if you will but super small
numbers in our case and then each of
these other forms just had each of these
other books has an identical form except
for the value of this year now in this
case this isn't such a big deal that a
user could technically hack the HTML of
this bookstore amazon.com and change the
IDS because whoa what's the worst
they're going to do like buy more books
by adding more IDs to their shopping
cart like that's not a problem there's
no prices here it's just the unique
ideas of books so whereas the deregister
was maybe worrisome because you're
changing the server I think it's okay
because the user can only at worst buy
more books than then uh they might via
the buttons alone so how does this now
work well let's go into vs code again
here let me give myself another terminal
window and in Source 9/ store let me
open up app.py which is where all the
logic is so I'll flip through most of
this quickly because we've seen this
before these Imports are pretty much the
same as before this line is the same
this line is almost the same but the
database now is called store. DB instead
of frost. DB this is the boilerplate
code for just enabling sessions this
notion of a shopping cart and so let's
see how the index Works how is that I'm
seeing all seven books at once well in
this index function I'm using on line 19
select star from books to get all the
books from the database and then I'm
rendering a template called books. HTML
passing in as a placeholder all of those
books all right let's go down that
rabbit hole for a second let me open up
books. HTML in my templates directory
and here again even though it's you know
new today it's probably increasingly
familiar syntactically here's the H1
here is my Loop here's the H2 which is
going to Output the current book's title
in that Loop here's the form here's the
ID of that book that's going to be
outputed in the form so I didn't
manually type out seven long forms I
just did one in this template so that it
gets generated automatically literally
what a website CL Amazon would do to
show you 10 books at a time or 10 search
results or more at a time all right well
let's go to SLC cart which was the juicy
one and this one's longer but let's see
if we can reason through it if the user
submits via get or post to/ cart well we
first do this and this is just necessary
in some boilerplate rewrote we're going
to use the session object to store a
variable called cart that in this case
is going to be a list so session again
is just a dictionary you can put
anything in it you want previously we
put students names and sports now uh
what I want to do is actually sorry prev
previously we put uh the student name
the user's name in it now I'm going to
actually store a cart key whose value is
a list why because I want to aggregate
more and more books in this list all
right so that just makes sure that I
have at least an empty shopping cart the
very first time the user does this if
they visit this form via post let's go
ahead and get the ID of the book that
they posted if it is not empty if there
is a number like one or two or three
let's go ahead and go into the shopping
C cart which is a list per this line and
just append that ID so this list of
books in your shopping cart is going to
contain like one comma 2 comma four
comma six whatever books you're actually
buying and then the user gets redirected
to cart what if though the user got here
via get and not post well this one's
relatively straightforward if you just
visit slart we select star from books
where ID is in okay so this is
interesting this list and and this is a
syntax you might not have seen before
but if you read the documentation for
cs50's Library if you select something
and use a question mark placeholder and
the placeholder itself is a list we
output a comma separated list of values
just like you would use maybe in problem
Set uh seven for doing SQL queries on
your own so this just means show me only
those books in my shopping cart not
Carters not someone else's not in the
whole database only show me the books in
my shopping cart and then
render it as such so we only saw what
the catalog here looks like at slash
books Let's go ahead and in slash let's
go ahead and add maybe the first book to
my cart and now I see at SLC cart only
that first book whose ID is one let me
now go back to the bookstore here scroll
down to maybe the seventh book and add
that to my cart and now I see this here
too meanwhile all of this information is
stored in my session and so when I
reload this cart again and again the
reason I'm only seeing my two is because
we're checking only the list in my
session and flasks make sure again that
my session is different from your
session is different from Carter's
session as well but you write the code
once and it works for thousands millions
of people in
parallel any questions on
this this yes in the
back sorry say a little louder
uh so to recap so users will never have
the same session values theoretically
the cookie that gets planted does not
look like a smiley face for everyone
each of us gets a big random number
that's assigned to us so it' be like
each of us gets a completely unique hand
stamp that no one else can see the
reason no one else can see it is because
if the website's using https every time
this hand stamp is shown every time this
cookie is sent back and forth It's all
encrypted as well so each of us can even
if we have the same contents by
coincidence because we like the same
books they will be separate cookies
separate memory separate sessions behind
you
yeah really good question when does the
session end totally configurable
typically it ends when you close the tab
or when you quit the browser or you can
also configure cookies to themselves be
persistent for a day for a week for
longer so for instance when you log into
um uh say Gmail they plant a cookie on
your computer probably for a week a
month a year something like that because
it would be annoying and probably drive
you to like Outlook or something else if
you kept having to log into your account
whereas your bank account might actually
wait for you to just close the tab and
then for your own Financial safety they
just automatically delete the session
far sooner but totally configurable by
default as I'm using it it will
typically be thrown away when the
browser itself quits and here too is
another reason to develop websites using
incognito mode because if you want to
just throw throw away all of your
cookies you close the incognito window
mode open a new one and now you're
starting from scratch you don't have to
manually delete all your cookies which
could log you out of websites you
actually care about
yeah a good question when using sessions
if someone maliciously changes the value
of sub forms could it affect other
people theoretically no because the
worst you can do is like add books to
your own shopping cart that you don't
want there so at that point even though
it's on the server it doesn't affect you
or Carter or anyone else unless there is
something more globally happening like
registering or deregistering for a sport
or removing books from the Amazon
database that would be problematic but
in this case we're removing things only
from my own session that the website is
giving me all right the last topic for
today is this thing here which is sort
of everywhere nowadays these things
called apis or application programming
interfaces and this is a very generic
term in fact because any function you've
used in C in scratch in Python in SQL
are all apis like there is a standard
way of interfacing with those functions
they all have names they sometimes have
return values they sometimes have
arguments and an API is just how you use
a function or more generally an API just
specifies how you interact with some
service and so nowadays there's a lot of
web-based services that you can use to
get back data like the weather or the
current time or the database of Amazon
books for instance all might have apis
often web-based that allow you using
URLs or some other technology to just
get data from someone else as though
it's a function you're calling remotely
but HTTP is very often the mechanism
that's used to actually get data from
servers and the way the data can come
back can be as follows let me end with
one final example using some of our
familiar shows from uh weeks past let me
go ahead and close the old flask version
version go back into Source 9 and go
into how about an example called shows
and the first version of this zero I'm
just going to go ahead and run with
flask run I'll hover over my URL and
open it here and you'll see now that I
have a very simple form as we keep doing
today I'm going to type in like o f f i
c office into this search box and click
search and you'll see now that I ended
up at a URL ending in/ search question
mark Q equals office so this is like my
own baby version of google.com but I
implemented it myself and for any title
of a TV show from a couple of weeks past
that matches o i I spit it out into an
unordered list how is this working you
can maybe imagine even if you might not
be able to program this off the top of
your head certainly so soon let me go
into Source 9 let me go into uh show
zero let me open up
app.py and in this file you'll see that
that I'm grabbing a uh file called
shows. DB which is like a simpler
version of the one from a couple of
weeks past uh here is why I see the web
form my first route my index is super
simple it just spits out that form and
my search route like you can think of
this as google.com there only like four
lines of code so if the user sends data
to SL search this function called search
is called I declare a variable called
shows I execute a SQL command that is
Select star from shows where title like
question mark and the syntax here is a
little crazy but I want to prefix to the
user's input percent sign and suffix it
with a percent sign as well putting in
the between those two values the actual
input why in SQL what is it mean if you
have a percent sign to the left and to
the right nothing to do with Ginger
today yeah it's a it's a wild card so it
means match zero or more characters on
the left or match zero or more
characters on the right you have to do
the concatenation
as the second argument to this function
you can't do something clever like put
it here around the like the is the
placeholder that you plug these values
into but this just means hey SQL show me
all of the titles that have o f i
somewhere in them that gives me back an
a list of dictionaries I pass that in as
a placeholder for a variable called
shows and if we look at search. HTML
let's look at that in my templates
directory there's something called
search. HTML super simple I mean this is
like the essence of google.com search
results I'm using an unordered list to
keep things simple but I iterate over
every show in the shows list that came
back and I output An Li with each of
those shows titles and that's it now
Google has like Blue Links and like
little previews and other text the first
sentence or so from each page but like
that's the idea like this is really
similar in spirit to what google.com
search does for you now how is this
working there's no API involved here yet
this is just very basic HTTP I submit
the the form I go to another route and I
get back the results but check out this
version Let me close these tabs here and
open my first terminal window let me go
into shows one from today's Source 9
directory and do flask run this time let
me go ahead and hover over that URL and
open it here and gone now is the submit
button now I'm going to make an user
interface that uses a technique called
Ajax for asynchronous uh JavaScript and
XML which is somewhat of a data term
because we're not using something called
ml anymore but Ajax is a technique
whereby you don't have to submit forms
anymore to get more data from the server
you can use JavaScript per last week
listen for an event like the key press
coming down or up and as soon as you
hear such an event you can secretly in
JavaScript code send a request to the
server to get back more data and then
plug it into the Dom the tree in the
computer's memory and this just makes
for more seamless experiences like
autocomplete on any website so now let
me try typing o okay we got auto
complete super fast f f i c e and you'll
see every time I add more keys to my
input I'm doing another search another
search another search and the data is
changing now how is this working well
let me go back to vs code here and in my
other terminal window let me open up uh
app.py and in app.py you'll see that
there's still a
search route down below that turns a
search template but watch this let me go
into templates search. HTML and notice
here that we're indeed getting back an
unordered list of shows again and again
and again and this HTML that's coming
back let me go here let me open my
terminal oh sorry this is the wrong
version uh sorry I was in the wrong
folder let's fix this and shows one code
of app.py it's almost the same thing
inserch
here okay well I changed this slightly
let me show you this version of search
if I open up app.py here's my search
route I'm getting a variable called Q
giving it the value of whatever request.
RX has from the user like Q equals
office and then I'm checking if the user
actually typed something in execute this
SQL query select star from shows where
title is like that using the same and
this time just to keep things efficient
I limited the total results to 50
instead of an infinite number otherwise
if the user type nothing just to be
super safe here I'm setting shows equal
to an empty list so if you don't type
anything there's nothing to show and no
matter what I render this template
called search. HTML well let's look at
that if I open up templat search. HTML
this time there's no layout there's no
inheritance of that layout. HTML I am
literally generating just a whole bunch
of Li fragments why well let's see what
what's happening in the browser and this
is the beginning of an API if I wanted
to make this API available this
application programming interface I
could tell the world that if you want to
search for TV shows in my database go to
URL that's something something/ search
question mark Q equals office or cat or
dog or anything else and what I will
return to you is this enter I will just
give you a whole bunch of Li tags which
almost looks the same but let me view
the page source only am I going to hand
you back a fragment of HTML I'm not
giving you an HTML tag a body tag a
title tag a head tag I'm not giving you
a web page I'm giving you a fragment of
HTML that you can now do whatever you
want including insert this into your own
unordered list so notice what happens in
this actual app if I go back to vs code
here let me open up my index template
here and you'll see some JavaScript
magic so in JavaScript here in my form
that only had the text box and no button
what am I doing in a script tag here I
am creating a variable called input and
I'm using this function called query
selector that just gets me a reference
to the input text box on the form so I
can see what the human typed this is a
little different today but I'm using
input. atevent listener which is a way
in JavaScript to tell it just like in
scratch listen for something to happen
like the green flag being clicked but in
this case listen for an event that
involves input that is like typing on
the keyboard whether it's by a copy
paste manual input or anything else then
whenever that happens call this function
and async stands for asynchronous this
is a term of art which means that this
this function might take like a split
second maybe even a second or two to
execute so it's going to do it behind
the scenes like in the background so to
speak and what is it going to do well
it's going to call a JavaScript function
that all browsers now Support called
Fetch which is a function that uses HTTP
to go fetch more data via the from the
server it's going to fetch data from a
route called SL search question mark Q
equals and whatever the value is that
the user typed in so I'm just sort of
manually creating my own mini URL and
telling JavaScript go fetch me that HTML
when it comes back via this line of text
here called response. text and let me
wave my hand at await await just means
this might not come back immediately
let's await the response and when it
does come and then let's execute this
code I'm going to do this I'm going to
search the document the whole web page
for this UL tag which is somewhere in
this page that we'll see in a moment
change its inner HTML to be that
fragment of Li Li Li of all of those
matching shows and where does this all
go well if we scroll up here you'll
notice that there's my usual HTML up at
top head tag body tag and all of that
there's the text box that we've talked
about already there's no button for
submitting cuz it all happens
automatically but there is by default
this empty UL that has nothing by
default until we start using that API
and the final flourish here is this this
is kind of a uh ugly sloppy way to get
data from a server to just get back like
a fragment of HTML like what if I'm not
using HTML I want to store these uh TV
shows in a PDF or in some other wet tag
in a table or something like that it
doesn't really make sense for the server
to be presuming that I want Li tags
surrounding each of my data better would
be to get a more generic format back and
that format is almost always nowadays
called this our final acronym Json
JavaScript object notation and let me do
this let me close these two tabs here
and open my terminal window and C cancel
the previous version of flask that was
running let me close this version and
look at our final version called shows
two and do flask run on I'm going to
hover over that URL and open it in a
browser and I'm going to manually visit
after zooming in let's do again slash uh
search question mark uh Q equals Office
enter and this is what Json looks like
now at a glance this does not seem like
an improvement like this looks crazy
that it's just this Big Blob of text but
it's just enough text for the computer
to be able to process it reliably notice
that there's a cur a square bracket here
and if I actually scroll to the Bott
botom there' be a closed square bracket
like way down there inside of that
square bracket is a curly brace then ID
colon and then a number then a title
quote unquote colon and then the title
and then the closed curly brace so what
you're seeing in JavaScript object
notation is a very standard super
popular format that's just text that
still uses square brackets for lists AKA
arrays that still uses curly braces for
dictionaries key value pairs so what you
see here is a massive list up to 50 I
think think shows that came back from
this API Each of which has a dictionary
if you will an object of key value pairs
what keys and values an ID key and a
title key Each of which has a value
respectively and this is the same data
from IMDb some of which you might be
recalling visually this is just a very
raw computer friendly way of returning a
whole bunch of data that we humans don't
need to see but I can use this data by
going back into vs code let me open
another terminal window and go into
Source
9/ shows 2 and in here let me go ahead
and open up how about uh templates
index.html which previously just used
that inner HTML trick and this is not
going to impress you're not going to be
pleased with this syntax but let me just
at least explain what we're doing it
turns out that Json is just the better
way in general the more generic
multi-purpose user agnostic language
agnostic way of returning data from a
server because it's just text so it
doesn't matter if you're using python or
C or C++ or JavaScript or Ruby or PHP or
something else like all of those
languages can process Json information
and indeed here is some JavaScript that
does just that same code as before
initially I declare a variable called
input that gives me access to the user's
text box I listen for input like key
strokes going up and down and when they
happen I call this Anonymous function uh
I fetch data from the server using the
exact same code as before search
question mark Q equals office or
anything else and then this is just now
new code that I use to convert that Json
data into my own HTML format be it an
unordered list an ordered list a table
or anything else what am I doing I've
got a variable called HTML initialized
to nothing so I've got no HTML initially
I then iterate over every ID in those
shows so every one of IMDB's unique
identifiers I iterate over them one at a
time and then I go into the show at its
ID location and I grab its title and
this
is forget this for just a moment I then
take this HTML variable concatenate or
join onto it my own Li tag plus the
title plus the close Li tag and I
skipped this because it got scary pretty
fast but it turns out that if some TV
shows have actually angled brackets in
that could break my HTML entirely so it
turns out you might recall super briefly
last week we had the copyright symbol
using an HTML entity using the Ampersand
and the hash symbol and 169 semicolon it
turns out there are other such cryptic
sequences of characters that represent
otherwise dangerous or untypable
characters like this which could confuse
the computer into thinking it's at the
beginning of a tag and an Amper sand
which could similarly trick the computer
into thinking that it's a entity which
it isn't but long story short there are
libraries thankfully that handle much of
this for you for our purposes the
takeaway is that now that you understand
a bit of
HTTP uh now that you understand a bit of
HTML CSS and JavaScript all of which
they have their roles you can use them
ultimately to start assembling your own
web applications as you will for problem
set nine um stitching together all of
those languages and building
full-fledged web applications mobile
applications or anything more and for
that I think we are all set and if the
first one up here uh can have these
cookies as well we'll see you next time
for our very last cs50
[Music]
lecture
good afternoon my name is Sarah and my
name is Grant and we are the Harvard
crocodillos and pitches now Sarah and I
understand that today is the final
lecture of cs50 it's been a tough
semester we made it through pets four
five and even Finance now I know this is
an unpopular opinion but I particularly
enjoyed Finance I spent a lot of time
with my
flask the P set there was a p
set well um at least things are looking
up um today is our last lecture and look
how far we've come if I were an emoji
right now I'd be the face with tears of
joy sorry about that we're just trying
to work some cs50 references into the uh
intro I I mean uh boy I sure hope this
uh tide man doesn't run off my Mario
filter you could say that for Loop x
equals Open Bracket one comma 2 close
bracket boy I sure wish we had checked
to see if these jokes were funny when we
wrote
them any who we hope that you'll enjoy
this brief
[Music]
serenade your
boot
[Music]
KN House of well there's
friers Andy truck barbecue ribs Tri
[Music]
the boy
boy bo boy bo bo boy boy down at the
house the house of well your root and
you walk on down to a knock down Shack
on the edge of town There's a l
there just quit you see
fall down the house the house
[Applause]
of up your boots and you walk on down
at the
house the House of Blue
Light to your down at the of
light
[Applause]
good afternoon everyone we are the
Harvard crocodillos and it is such an
honor to be here with the Radcliff
pitches performing for cs50's final
lecture congratulations to everyone and
we hope you'll enjoy this our tribute to
cs50 one two one 1 2 3
4 C is for the language I once knew O is
for all notation I must do D is for
dynamic flask run and finance it is even
more than David May in canor so code is
all that I can give to you to youe
debugging it since
PE soon deadlines I'll make it hit
compile and please don't break it code
was made by
[Music]
foru
I for notation I must do
is
Dam even
more is
[Music]
I is for the language 0 1 0 1 0 oh is
for otation 0 1 1 D is for dynamic flas
run and finance e is even more than
David mail in canor so C is all that I
can give to
you debugging it since
PE soon deadlines I'll make it hit
compile and please don't break it code
was made by me for COD was made by me
for COD was
[Music]
by all
right
all right this is cs50 and cs50 this was
the Harvard crocodillos and the Radcliff
pitches if one more time we could thank
them for joining us
today so this is already week 10 our
last and indeed among the goals for
today are to hopefully give you all the
more of appreciation of truly just how
far you've come recall that in week zero
we began with this this visual here
whereby it was described this class as a
bit of a fire hose whereby drinking from
that fire hose or really a fire hose
from a water fountain uh is not unlike
getting an education down the road too
and so this is to say that if you're
feeling like you didn't quite get it all
down like that's actually okay and
that's to be expected and even if you
felt that with each passing week 0 1 two
all the way up now till 10 it never
really ever got easier perhaps just
consider that what was once hard like
Mario and like getting hello world to
compile is indeed the right measure of
the Delta between week Zer and now in
week 10 in fact you might recall that
again in week zero 2third of your
classmates had never taken a CS course
before now of course you all have and
indeed if you think back too to this
final sentiment from week zero that
indeed what ultimately matters in this
course is not where you end up relative
to your classmates but where you end up
relative to where you yourself began so
I would take some pride take some
satisfaction take some relief even
though a little bit more work does
remain at really just how far you've
come since that week zero and recall
that in week zero we literally started
with just zeros and ones and by now many
of you might have gleaned that these 64
zeros and ones have been spelling
something week by week in fact today is
our very last message here in binary uh
encoded on stage but then quickly we
introduced scratch and we started to
assemble some building blocks of
programming Loops conditions uh uh Loops
conditions functions and the like but
without all the distractions of
semicolons and curly braces and all of
that which admittedly we introduce the
next week when we introduce you to C but
even now that we've transitioned to
python hopefully even those kinds of
Curiosities or confusions are hopefully
starting to just get more familiar and
so you finally start to see the missing
semicolon as opposed to spending time on
that kind of struggle recall too that in
week two we started talking already
about memory and like how you can manage
things in arrays that later became of
course in Python lists uh the week after
we talked not only about uh debugging uh
bugs in code but how to debug those same
programs um thereafter we started
talking talking about algorithms and we
took a step back from code and looked at
the bubble sorts and the selection sorts
and the merge sorts and all of the
searches as well that go hand in hand
with that and indeed this ultimately is
what a lot of problem solving moving
forward is going to be about just
solving problems with some form of
algorithm and you have so many different
languages um in your toolkit now with
which to approach problems like those we
talk thereafter about pointers which are
not likely to come back in any modern
languages that you now use but hopefully
you have an all the better of a sense
underneath the hood of like what's going
on inside of the computer so that when
you're designing something you're using
something something crashes you at least
have a mental model for what's going on
and it's no longer that week zero black
box as it once was I mean you built
things like this think back to week five
when you built your own hash table and
those things are everywhere key value
pairs whether it's in python or in C or
if it's now in CSS and JavaScript and
even HTML like that principle of key
value pairs is really everywhere and so
of course now code doesn't necessarily
have to look like this it now
wonderfully looks a little something
more like this but eventually you're
probably not I'm not going to use Python
anymore something new and better is
going to come along but odds are like a
lot of the building blocks from these
past 11 weeks are still going to be
useful for wrapping your mind around
those new worlds and indeed SQL we
introduced you a little bit too and even
if you don't feel yourself yet an expert
hopefully have a sense of like what you
can do with it and what problems you can
solve uh it's of course a better
alternative to something like something
simple like a spreadsheet and now of
course like web stuff is everywhere
whether it's on your laptop or desktop
or a lot of the mobile apps that you use
on your phone even though they're native
applications like you install them from
Google Play or the Apple App Store like
they're implemented increasingly with
HTML CSS and JavaScript but they're put
in a little rectangular window so you
don't even notice that that's actually
really just an embedded browser and then
of course you can build things as you
might for your final project that to
might very well be web based if you go
that route I mean I'm still clinging to
like the very first like web app I ever
made years ago um but honestly I do that
in part because I was just so darn proud
that like I taught myself how to do
something and it actually worked and was
used by other people so whether it's
just used by you or your classmates or
your roommates or your family or your
company down the line there's a great
sense of satisfaction that comes despite
all of the the pain that might be along
the way when you just can't see or fix
that bug now of course we'll transition
as you'll see in the coming days to try
empowering you to code client side as
well up until now you've been using our
own vs code installation in the cloud
which is nice cuz you got up in running
super fast in week one focusing only on
code challenges not on technical
difficulties but among the goals now if
you so choose and want to program after
this class even if you never take
another CS course before you can use
these same real world deao standard
tools on your own Mac or PC and so
pictured here is a screenshot of like vs
code on the Mac and even though yes
you're going to have to like jump
through a couple of more Hoops to just
get python or some other language
working on your own Mac or PC like
that's what programming is ultimately
going to be about and we deliberately
transition you to this at terms end so
that now you have 11 weeks of more
Comfort under your belt with which to
solve sort of silly technical support
headaches that might have been deal
breakers so many weeks ago so there's
still more to be done uh in the coming
weeks and indeed a support structure
there for the cs50 hackathon of course
will be this 700 p.m. till 7 a.m.
opportunity to dive into your final
project well really continue diving into
your final project ideally at that point
uh alongside classmates perhaps your
project Partners if you're working
collaboratively
uh and awaiting you will be such
memories and excitement hopefully as
these even as you then turn your
attention back to your final project
there of course will be several meals
during the day culminating with 500 a.m.
uh shuttles to IHOP the local Pancake
Place uh if you are so awake at that
point or even if you get there uh this
is not an uncommon site as you might
recall from week zero and then lastly is
the cs-50 fair which is finally back
after a couple of years now of it not
being on campus and this will be an
opportunity for everyone to present
their final projects to passers by
classmates faculty and staff and really
just Delight in what it is you created
on your Mac your PC your phone in the
cloud or anywhere else and indeed it's
just going to be an opportunity to bring
your laptop to a shared space or your
phone and introduce your project to
passers by such as might appear and
ultimately celebrate what you all uh
accomplished and indeed will you be
handed at the cs50 fair your very own I
took cs50 t-shirt which I dare say I'm
still wearing all of these years later
and so you
to
we'll have that uh ahead of you as well
so for what's on the agenda today we
thought we would not only look back but
look forward but first we wanted to
thank so many of the team members that
have been helping both on stage and off
who've made this course and these
sections and so much more about cs50
possible of course um the building that
we are now in there's a whole team
downstairs in Memorial Hall who helps us
get set up and organized each day our
thanks to them there's the education
Support Services team who makes
everything look and sound so well down
here especially when we have all of the
more microphones as well our friends the
harbard crocodillos and the redcliff
pitches most recently and then of course
cs50's own team uh but butter cs50's own
favorite restaurant Chang show down the
road indeed if you find yourself in
Cambridge for the next one two 3 four
years or visiting from out of town uh do
pay a visit to our friends just down the
road and in fact we'll have our very
last cs50 lunch this Friday if you're
able locally to partake and then there
cs50's own team um both on stage and off
in thanks truly because not only do they
make the everything run so smoothly they
capture it for students here who might
not be physically present here for our
friends down in New Haven at Yale and
certainly for anyone online who might be
tuning in as well and then lastly wanted
to thank of course the huge team of your
classmates your peers that make cs50
possible in sections and office hours
tutorials and more allow me to share
with you the outtakes so that even we
the teaching staff sometimes struggle
with computer science here are some of
the clips that we captured when just
passing packets via tcpip a while back
you saw the finally the the nicely
polished version but here are if I may
if we could dim the lights are some of
the
outakes nothing
go buffering
okay Josh
nice
[Music]
Helen no oh wait
that was amazing
Josh uh um
[Music]
Sophie
amazing that was
perfect
B I think
I what
you oh nice
[Music]
guy that was amazing thank you all so
good indeed and that moment if we could
just one round of applause for everyone
who's helped out this
semester so back in week zero uh we
introduced you of course to this idea of
computational thinking which is to think
a a little more methodically a little
more algorithmically and by way of these
various languages hopefully that is
something you notice maybe not in the
moment but in the months and the years
to come that you do find that your
thoughts are indeed a little more
cleaned up and you're just able to
express yourself a little more precisely
and even spot illogic in someone else's
document or statements as well but at
the end of the day really a course like
this is also about critical thinking and
indeed rewind again to week zero when we
frame the entirety of computer science
is really just this like problem solving
and any problem in the world be it CS or
otherwise has some input and we decided
how to represent those inputs it needs
some output the solution there too and
then all of what you focused on doing
and learning and applying these past
several weeks is in that proverbial
black box which hopefully is not such an
abstraction anymore but is indeed
something that you know how to harness
and know what could be going on
underneath the hood even if it's in some
technology or some language that maybe
we ourselves didn't cover because a lot
of those first principles remain the
same now along the way we talked about
the quality of solutions to those
problems we happen to focus on
correctness just does it work design
which is a bit more qualitative and
subjective and then style the Aesthetics
of it all and these two are
characteristic maybe not with these same
words of just how you might write or
evaluate other creations in life be it
physical or written or the like so think
about too as you solve problems just how
you can sort of frame for yourself like
am I doing a good job or not by
quantizing it along these or perhaps
other axes as well and we thought we'd
highlight just two topics from that week
zero that have really been manifest for
the past several weeks namely
abstraction like taking complicated
things and ideas and trying to simplify
them so that we can sort of operate at
this level and like solve problems we
care about without getting into the
weeds of implementation detail so to
speak but there's this tension because
you know now from all of these different
languages that code is fairly
unforgiving I mean even omitting a
stupid semicolon sometimes breaks
everything and so Precision is sort of
at odd sometimes with this idea of
leveraging abstraction and so we thought
we would try to tease this apart
especially all these Weeks Later here uh
with a bit of a uh live demonstration so
on the way in you probably all received
a sheet of paper if not but someone near
you did just tear theirs in half and
borrow half a sheet if you can or any
piece of loose leaf paper or the like
will suffice so long as you have a pen
or pencil and for this allow me to
propose that we invite up maybe two
final cs50 volunteers this semester and
like a lot of hands are going up in this
okay a lot of hands how about I saw the
first hand there uh yes yes who's yes
who's pointing at herself now come on
down we just need the one hand for now
but oh wait oh wait uh you'll be our
number two well okay we have way too
many volunteers now no no please please
come down yes in the black shirt and if
you guys we will okay we'll do pair
programming in just a bit if you want to
hang out in the wings here we'll have
our second demonstration as well so okay
now maybe a round of applause for our
three
volunteers oh come on up first oh second
and third okay you come first we'll do
order no uh this is a q okay Q here okay
what's your name I'm Danny Danny okay
take this mic okay so we will DQ you
momentarily all right so Danny come on
over to the middle here and in a moment
I'm going to hand to Danny a sheet of
paper that has a picture on it and this
picture is going to be something that
I'd like you to verbally program the
audience to draw you can use any words
any abstractions any PR level of
precision that you want but you just
can't make hand gestures or sort of show
them what to draw But first you want to
tell us a little something about
yourself including everyone here I'm
daddy and I took ts50 okay wonderful
wonderful so I'm going to reveal the
picture only to Danny and if each of you
would like to take out that sheet of
paper and just make sure that no one
else can see this if you want to hold it
up this way everyone here is now holding
their pen or pencil and in some number
of steps give them a verbal algorithm
for drawing what you see and you can say
anything you want but no gestures okay
so you're going to want to
draw a square in the center of the paper
with the
diagonal pointing to
the center of the
edge wait no actually I scratched that
draw a rbus in the center of your
paper and for those who forget what a
rhombus is for um a d
Diamond a a square that's on its
side and then from the bottom vertex
draw a straight line down but not all
the way to the edge of the
paper okay and then keep your pencil or
pen at that point and you're going to
want to draw a line that's parallel to
the line of the original rumus to the
right and then keep your pencil or pen
at that point and draw a line straight
up connecting to the side
vertex yes and then go back to the line
that you drew from the bottom vertex to
the bottom of the paper and then draw a
line parallel to the left edge of the
rumus and then then keep your L your
paper your pencil at that point and draw
a line up to the vertex of the rumus
again the end the end all right well
thank you to Danny hang on to your paper
thank you so much and if you want to
step off to the stage there we will
reveal thank you a round of applause if
we could for Danny that is not an easy
task I'm sure and if Carter wouldn't
mind just grabbing a few samples here
let's actually take a look on the
overhead if we could I'm going to pop
down over here real fast we don't need
to collect them all but if you're
feeling either good or bad with what you
drew happy to collect a few of them
okay okay thank you thank
you okay hope you won't mind if I can't
reach everyone just a couple more okay
over here okay all right that's that's
okay this one's really funny okay I'm
going to go with this one if I may and
Carter has some
too
okay thank you so much okay so just a
random assortment here let me turn on a
camera so I can show you what I see here
for instance is one classmate drawing
which might resemble perhaps what you
drew here uh here is the beginnings of a
house it
seems nice this
one okay this one is larger
and how about a couple of others that
were getting closer I think okay so more
edges and vertices there this one seems
a little similar in
spirit if not
proportional this is uh Zach's the best
one but it turns out if I may Zach
you're not all that far off here Denny
is what you were reciting to everyone
algorithmically indeed it was this here
Cube and so Danny can you come on back
up for a
moment so if you'd like to share for
just a moment like what were some of the
thoughts going through your head and why
did you choose the words that you did
okay so what was going through my head
when I saw the cube um I didn't know if
I could say draw Cube so I decided to
start with the top and so draw a Remus
in the center of your paper and then
draw a line down and just like do the
first part then the second part then the
third part and then you would get a cube
like Zach yeah and so had you said and
you could have said draw a cube which
would be more of an abstraction even
that's not necessarily sufficiently
precise right because you don't
necessarily know what the orientation of
that cube is the size of it the
positioning on the paper so you instead
took a lower level approach which is not
unlike scratch if you think about
scratch being able to move up down left
right turn 90 degrees turn 15 degrees
and the like I mean that is ultimately
how a lot of graphical programs and
games even might be implemented by
really focusing at the level you do but
of course there's this tension with us
humans whereby we prefer often to think
at this level but even that might not be
sufficient which is to say here in week
10 like these are still going to be in
our hard problems uh but a hand if we
could one more time for Danny for
getting us that far along thank you so
much let me give you a stress ball here
all right and if we could have both of
our volunteers come up here we're going
to have yes come on up come on up and
let me uh have you guys introduce
yourselves in the middle
here hi I'm
hey there I'm sadik from Turkey nice to
meet you all wonderful welcome and this
time we're going to flip it around so as
to have the audience do what Danny just
did for us the only catch here is that
the only means we have for showing the
audience what they need to tell you to
draw is like literally right above the
chalkboard so on our system here that
your eyes must stay on the chalkboard
and not look up and in just a moment if
you guys want to both stand in front of
the chalkboard back to the audience and
as you're talking with each other other
verbalize it through the microphone if
you will I'm going to show everyone else
in the room a second and final drawing
and we'll just go rapid fire around the
room give us one step at a time
collectively and we'll see if these guys
can't draw exactly that same outcome so
is there another chunk what's that is
there another chunk or just just the one
so you'll have to collaborate and let's
give you a clean slate here
literally all right so no looking up
that's the only rule for you guys here
we go for the audience here is what we'd
like them ironically to
draw step one from anyone in the
audience yes draw a circle draw a circle
anywhere not anywhere not
anywhere okay that's step one step two
someone else yeah in the
middle
draw a line down from the bottom of the
circle about halfway down I think there
was a hand in front of you too number
three
[Music]
okay okay the overarching goal here for
those unable here is to draw a person
fig okay it may be a SI figure draw the
left leg of the person of this person
okay good job all right next step four
yeah
of line up Circle
okay the left oh sorry to the right draw
a v okay to the right of the vertex at
the bottom of the circle draw a v draw a
v um like what V nope not interactive
draw a v um no no
well yeah it seems Weir
weird let's get ready for maybe
something like step
five okay we'll go with that step five
someone else step five someone else
someone else
yeah draw the right side of the leg okay
nice step six step six happy face six
six yes erase the line
erase the line that you have on the left
on the
okay okay step seven yes instead of like
that line that was before going up make
it go down instead of that line before
going up make it go down mhm okay step
eight step eight step eight yes connect
that line to the hip connect that line
to the hip not like not touching not
touching something like this
maybe okay compromise not touching okay
not touching okay all right step nine
almost there I think step
nine step nine step nine yes in
back uh write the word high on the top
left of the circle
here okay
and step 10 almost there line draw a
line pointing to high so like a spee
bubble basically
yeah okay and step uh 10
yeah erase the exclamation point nice 12
do we want to give them one
more 12 or we good yeah last one erase
the erase erace the right arm okay I
think we're going to need a 13
then and
then yeah
repat repeat the left arm but rotate it
by
90° that feels
wrong wait how would you like as an
organic human being how put your
arms like would you put your would you
ever structure your arm like that that
would not be a stick
figure CU would you do this or would you
do that or a little hint maybe get a get
a give me a step 14 step 14 and final
step
14 I think we just got to tell them what
to do step 14
yes think of a walking man
and and have the left the right hand
walking to your right all right so like
it's like where could the hand go where
should the hand go on that
arm but yeah yeah okay yes
no yeah I mean look look look like right
here look right here look right I yes
sorry thank you 14
St that's pretty close so
congratulations to you guys and thank
you as well all right so I mean these
these things too are not yes Round of
Applause then sure
so so this is to say that these ideas of
abstraction and precision and really
every other term of art that we explored
this term are sort of omnipresent and
can be easier or harder to implement
depending on exactly what the problem is
but what we thought we' do now in our uh
final day is try to now similarly
prepare prepare you for life after cs50
and this is really going to be a list of
really potential to-dos so that you can
stand on your own after the class after
the class's infrastructure write actual
code and then we'll come full circle one
final time with our friend Jennifer 8
Lee to look at the world of emojis and
how they relate to all forms of
representation that we've talked to uh
talked about up until now so one how can
you go about programming after cs50 so
one you can actually install command
line tools on your own Mac or PC perhaps
unbeknownst to you Windows has what's
generally called a command prompt Mac OS
literally comes with a terminal program
in your applications utilities folder
and so even if you've never run those
programs you've actually had a sort of
blinking cursor black and white prompt
available to you might not have all of
the same software installed as your code
space in the cloud but you have that
command line interface even within
today's graphical tools and among the
tools you can install within that
command line interface would be
something called xcode on the Mac which
comes not only with a guey IDE
integrated development environment but
also those command line tools and
Microsoft for Windows has something
similar as well learning git so we've
used git only unbeknownst to you
underneath the hood for the most part
but git is a very very popular tool if
challenging to pick up for the first
time that makes it easy to push code to
a website called GitHub or any
equivalent and then collaborate more
effectively with classmates there's
definitely a bit of a learning curve but
thanks to cs50's own Brian youu you can
start for instance with a video like
this and this indeed is going to be one
of these deao standards in the real
world at least for the next several
years that you'll probably encounter if
you work in Tech or really any company
where you're doing some programming vs
code itself will walk you through this
process in the coming days but you can
indeed install it on your own Mac or PC
and what can you do when you write code
well you can certainly write software
for your Mac for your PC for your phone
or of course per week 10 uh week nine
you can host uh your own website be it
static as in week uh week eight um
hosting it at websites like these which
gener generally have free or
student-friendly accounts via which you
can put something statically on the web
at a real domain name that you might
choose or you can host a full-fledged
web app and using uh student tiers on
Amazon and Microsoft and Google's cloud
services or others you can sign up for
being a student certainly a whole lot of
free software free hosting so as to if
nothing else um experiment and uh
perhaps maximally get your own app or
website up and running so know that
those are resources available to you and
this is by uh certainly a non-exhaustive
list if you'd like to geek out in the
coming months in the coming years these
are just some of the places that people
who take computer science classes who
write code might tend to hang out and
ask and answer questions of each other
um so keep an eye for instance on these
here and then cs50 has its own
communities as you'll see if you go to
this URL here via the open coreware
version of cs50 which is open to the
world do uh is there a Vibrant Community
uh thanks to time zones that's pretty
much active 247 365 talking about not
only cs50 going on in problem sets and
projects but really technology more
generally as well so certainly feel
welcome to partake either asking or
answering questions now in speaking of
asking and answering questions a couple
of weeks ago you kindly gave us a whole
bunch of review questions which we
called through and picked out our
favorite 20 of them these of course were
multiple choice questions and in
preparation for this week uh in
preparation for life ahead we thought we
would choreograph a bit of a a quiz show
here and ceed as you came in at the
start of class you might recall being
invited to go to this URL here
cs50. either here in person or if you're
watching live from home at this URL here
you can use a phone or a laptop and if
it's easier on a phone you can point
your camera at this 2D barcode here
we'll give folks a moment to pull that
up and again that URL was cs50.
l/p
and once it looks like most folks have
it up and running our friend Carter here
will help us dive into this uh review
session if you will with a bit of fun
along the way all right Carter if you'd
like to take it away what do we have as
our first question you should see on
your phone or laptop this same question
being asked the first question is how do
you print quote un quote hello world in
Python so among the possible answers are
these here
buzz in on your phone or your
laptop we've got a few hundred responses
are
ready 7 Seconds to make your
decision this is question one of 20 go
to it with some confidence I think we're
down to zero on the clock and Carter it
looks like 98% of you uh indeed said
hello world and Carter per the check
mark That's indeed the correct answer
here now to make things interesting in
know that you'll see some number of
points and we've deliberately anonymized
it so only you know what number you are
so a whole lot of guests have a perfect
score of 1,000 at the moment hopefully
we'll see over the next several
questions things start to bridge out uh
but know that the speed with which you
buzz in will also factor into how many
points you now get So the faster you
move the more points you get question
two if we could what does DNS stand for
from just a couple of weeks back domain
number system domain name system data
numbering structure or there's no such
thing as
DNS few hundred responses are
in 8 seconds
remain fewer points now but still a
chance to buzz in and now as we hit zero
the responses are these domain name
system which is indeed correct and 84%
of you got that one correctly and indeed
exists we talked about it a couple of
weeks ago so we're still seeing a whole
lot lot of ties at 2,000 we'll see if
someone starts to pull away before long
question three what is the upper bound
of merge sorts
runtime so that escalated
quickly Big O of n log n Big O of log n
Theta or Omega of log n or Big O of
one what is the upper bound of merge
sorts
runtime that was the last of the
algorithms we solve for sorting and in 1
second we'll see that the correct answer
is is just edging out everyone else
indeed 46% it is n I know it's n log now
if I may as the teacher it can't be
login because login is strictly less
than n and you can't possibly sort n
elements unless you minimally look at or
touch each of them so it's got to be at
least greater than n intuitively we
still have a whole bunch of ties let's
move on to number four what is stored in
ARG
C back to the language C is it in Array
of arguments the maximum size of an
array the count of arguments given to a
program when first run or how much
memory is allocated to a
function again you wrote all of these
questions and we have 5 seconds for the
reveal ARG C
is indeed the count of arguments given
to a program when first run think back
to C when we did command line arguments
there was argc and arv argv was the
array but Arc was indeed the count the
CN AR save all right we still have a
whole bunch of ties at the top here but
let's move on then to number five what
is the duck debugger favorite hobby
according to one of your classmates
dressing up like Dracula swimming across
the stage filling up the entire bathroom
of a guy's house and sitting quietly on
stage the third of course is a reference
to a YouTube video that was on the
course's website that week but according
to your class mate number two seconds
remaining sitting quietly on stage is
its favorite pastime so a little harder
perhaps than the
others 5,000 now we're starting to see
some spread so we only have six six
guests in contention for first place and
the next question now is six what is the
function used to open a file in
C F open open file open
file
what is the function used to open a file
in
C 7
Seconds there's some differences between
C and python here and the reveal it is
indeed fop it's 77% correct too all
right let's see the rankings now if you
are guest 15 9715 6171 3753 or 3273
you're now in the lead as we move on on
to se question seven how does Sterling
compute the average sorry how does
Sterling compute the length of a string
in C it looks at how much memory the
string uses it counts the number of
characters until it reaches back0 it
counts the number of bits in the string
or it creates pointers for each
character and counts
them 10 seconds Sterling in
C recall that we implemented this
ourselves in class but then we used the
library thereafter and in indeed with
85% it simply counts the number of
characters until it reaches that
Sentinel back sl0 AKA null and in this
case we
have five four four of you tied now for
first all right question eight where
does Malo allocate memory
from the stack the Heap the pointers or
the
temp where does malok allocate memory
from responses are coming in 8
seconds a good review question at that
in two seconds we'll see that malok
allocates memory from woo close one the
Heap is correct the Heap is correct the
stack recall is where functions store
their local variables and their
arguments and that just happens
automatically the Heap represented in
our pictures up top is where malok draws
from now we have guest
15 has
made its way to the top here but others
can catch up if they don't buzz in fast
enough so number nine how many people
flew from 50v to New York on the day of
the
crime 16 29 8 or
three anyone with a laptop perhaps has
an advantage
here 5 Seconds
and the answers are but the answer is
16 let's see if guest 15 got
this they did not goodbye to guest 15 at
the top all right question 10 we're
about halfway there what are meta tags
used for in
HTML to describe a web page to Define
parameters for an element to group
elements together to translate content
into machine readable format
at what are meta tags used for in HTML
we saw a few of
them for different use
cases and with one second we see that
indeed the number one answer was to
describe the web page be it for a mobile
device be it for screen scrapers like
Facebook and Twitter and other such apps
that grab images and descriptions
thereof all right we're in the second
half now guest nine guest four 669 has
edged ahead guess 15 is now in sixth
place all right number 11 is how do you
find the address of a variable in C
think back a few weeks star dollar sign
Ampersand or
ask from one of your own classmates how
do you find the address of a variable in
C and the number one answer is ersan
which is indeed the address of operator
at 62% nicely done let's see who's the
top of the list now guess 4669 has
retained their lead so we move on to 12
what does the arrow operator mean in C a
hyphen and a greater than sign nothing
starts a comment replaces a star and Dot
operator declares a
pointer what does this Arrow operator
mean in
C
again from a few weeks back 3 seconds
harder assortment perhaps and it's oh
replaces a star and Dot operator the
number two answer was indeed correct
this was just a cleaner way syntactic
sugar for collapsing what would be a
star and then some parentheses and then
a DOT into quite simply something that
looks like an arrow itself all right
Carter who's in the lead now still that
same guest and let's see what 13 has for
us which of these is not a data type in
SQL light blob string integer
text we used a few of these more
commonly than others but not all of
these are for
real 5 Seconds to make your
decision and the results are blob is a
thing string is not in SQL light it's of
course called text as we've seen it blob
as goofy as it sounds is just binary
large object but indeed it's how you
might store a binary file in your
database all right the rankings now oh
guest 8444 has Eed ahead so we move on
to 14 which of the following is a valid
way to print Exclamation point
Exclamation point Exclamation point
Exclamation point in
Python I'll let you read these
yourselves
which is a valid
way everyone got quiet in is
thinking all right 6 seconds few hundred
responses in so
far all right and yes nicely done 78% is
correct you can use the star operator to
essentially multiply the character at
left all right who's in the lead Carter
we now have still G guest
8444 and so we move on now to 15 what
does the free function do D allocates
memory from A Primitive deallocates
memory at the given pointer terminates a
loop or returns a value from the
function what does the free function
do all right 5 Seconds what does the
free function do call it's the opposite
essentially of malok and it deallocates
the memory at the given pointer as well
and in C that's on you in Python you
don't need to worry about allocating or
freeing aik all right we now have at the
top still guest 8444 and seeing more and
more spread 16 which is not a step of
compiling think back now to week two
compiling pre-processing linking or
threading which is not a step of
compiling we use it as a catchall but it
technically means a few different things
collectively all right and threading is
indeed not on the list that is a
technical thing generally meaning a
program can do multiple things at once
but that is not related here to
compiling all right guest 8444 is still
at the top we have just a few questions
left and so 17 what was the surprise at
the beginning of the Halloween lecture
according to your classmates someone
scared me someone hid candy under every
chair someone dressed up as me the
entire staff dressed up as
Carter interesting litmus test of who
came to or watch lecture
perhaps let's see which guests got this
correct someone someone's really dressed
up as indeed me at 64% so I think we
have attendance here essentially from
that lecture so let's move on now to the
final few questions after seeing that
guest a 8444 8444 is still doing well
can anyone Dethrone them why is it
incorrect to use the equals equals
operator in C to compare
strings it's computationally inefficient
you comparing the locations of the
strings strings don't exist using equal
equals will lead to buffer
overflow why is it incorrect to use
equal equals in C to compare strings 3
seconds we saw this live and it
motivated like an entire week because
you're comparing the locations that is
the addresses in memory of those same
strings all right let's see if this
leaves the rankings the same guest 8444
is still at the top and pulling ahead
two final questions 19 what is the
difference between null one L and null 2
L's they null and null mean the same
thing nulls refers to back sl0 whereas
null to L's is the zero address null is
the zero address whereas null to L's
refers to back sl0 null is null but
lazier 5
Seconds subtle not the best design
perhaps to have in technical terms but
indeed 62% of you got that NL is the
first thing we talked about when we
talked about back sl0 and N is a pointer
it's the zero pointer same thing same
number but different context all right
Carter guest 8444 is the person to beat
with our final 20th questions what do
the binary bulbs on stage spell
today and these are your four choices
different from usual we usually use 8
bit asky today we are using utf8 which
is a form of Unicode which is the larger
subset that uses one or two or three or
even four bites to spell a single
character and the answer wow close close
is indeed a cupcake indeed a cupcake
well done and let's see the final
results 8444 is the winner are they here
in person perhaps
8444 you're 844 come on
[Applause]
down thank you here you go
congratulations oh you're all right so
today if we
may give me just one
moment all
right all right so today we are so
pleased to be joined by uh Jennifer 8
Lee who's an of the college a dear
friend and is actually really the reason
why there's evidence of Muppets in cs50
in fact some years ago I was visiting
her and she had on her shelf like this
custom Muppet it wasn't one that appears
on TV but she had somehow gone on a
website former toy store called FAO
Schwarz at the time and you're allowed
to configure your own Muppet whatnot
choose the eyes the nose the face and
the Torso and I just thought this was
the coolest thing and so in the taxi on
the way home I was like going on the
website trying to purchase our very
first Muppet I then woke up the next
morning thinking why did I just buy a
puppet in the back of a taxi and so it
sat on the shelf for really 2 years and
then a colleague of mine within cs50's
team decided after I brought it into the
office to sit on a shelf there to
actually bring it to life and indeed if
you Google around cs50 Muppet and
puppetry online you'll see in fact these
as characters not only over the past
couple of years in coid times when
really there was next to no one actually
here and so they were instead um but
indeed she's brought not only this this
educational element this pedagogical
element this playful element El to cs50
and we have her here today to speak to
exactly the sorts of encodings that are
here on stage Jenny is the former Vice
chair of the Unicode subcommittee on
emoji which is to say that she and her
colleagues have been influential in
taking emoji from what was a very
limited character set early on and by
far unrepresentative of much uh human
emotion in speech into really an
initiative now to capture digitally all
of the world's languages past present
and future as well as the range of
emotions that might see here in the form
of that pillow or even in the cake that
awaits so allow me to introduce Jennifer
8 Lee thank
[Music]
you I much drink okay clicker hi all
right hold on I have to hide my drinks I
might need more water all right um I'm
really excited to speak to speak here
last time last year I was here uh one I
was wearing a mask which is like a real
bummer if you're lecturing and then the
entire like front part was all Muppet so
I'm really happy to see humans actually
um and it's always an honor to speak at
Sanders and and then Dave and I were
actually classmates way back when so I
do remember him when he was an undergrad
much like you so I um I'm going to give
a talk on the world of emoji and how I
kind of became an emoji activist so it
kind of all starts um with my friend e
inl who is a designer who's well known
for doing the Twitter fail whale which
was kind of laid to rest except now this
week it seems like it may be like may be
necessary again um so she and I one day
were texting this is back in 2015 we're
texting about dumplings because we are
Chinese is women and we like like to
text about food and so I sent her this
picture of dumplings she was like yum
yum yum yum yum yum yum yum um and then
she was like oh Apple doesn't have a
dumpling emoji and I was like oh that's
kind of interesting and didn't really
think anything about it because like you
know people Point things out to you all
the time and then you just like forget
you just like move on but then half an
hour later um on my phone appears this
like dumpling with hard eyes and you
don't see it in in because it's a still
shot but it actually had like blinking
eyes so she liked to call it like bling
bling dumpling so she as a designer had
decided to like go in and like make her
own dumpling Emoji um because she was
like I'm a designer I can fix it but
that actually got me thinking I was like
where do Emoji come from and like how is
there not a dumpling Emoji cuz from my
perspective dumplings are this kind of
universal food right so and there are a
lot of Japanese Foods
on the emoji keyboard and I I was not
this was like back in 2015 I was like
not a big Emoji user like at all so I
mean you have things like Ramen you have
Bento boxes you have Curry you have
tempura you even have like kind of
obscure um kind of foods like this thing
things on a stick turns out to be fish
fish things on a stick then this pink
and white white swirly thing is also a
fish thing and there's even like that
triangle rice ball that looks like it's
had a bikini wax all well represented on
the Emoji Keyboard but no dumplings and
it's very strange cuz like all cultures
kind of have their dumpling right
whether or not it's um kinali or ravioli
or aanas like essentially everyone sort
of like discover the idea of like um
yummy goodness inside a carbo hydrate
carbohydrate shell whether not baked or
fried or um steamed so I was like okay I
literally Google I was like who controls
emoji and you discover that they're
actually regulated by a nonprofit called
the Unicode Consortium and um it is you
know and I just like went on their
website and I discovered that they had
12 full voting members as of 2015 so
this is 2015 and they were like mostly
us multinational tech companies it was
Oracle it was IBM Microsoft Adobe Google
Apple Facebook and Yahoo and of the
three that were not multinational US
tech companies they were let's see a
German company called sap a Chinese
Telecom company called Huawei and then
like the government of Oman like those
were basically the 12 full voting
members of the US multi-national tech
companies so they at that point paid um
$118,000 a year to have full voting
power on the you know Unicode committee
and I was like oh that's a that's a lot
of money and I kind of felt indignant
about this and uh but then like if you
kind of keep on digging on their website
you found like there was this kind of
interesting loophole which is you could
join as an individual for
$75 um you don't get voting power but it
gave you the right to put yourself on
the email list and also to like attend
the quarterly Unicode meeting so I was
like I'll do that I had no idea what I
was doing but I'm like I'm going to go
fight um for this dumpling Emoji because
from my perspective dumplings are
Universal Emoji are kind of universal so
uh the fact there was no dumpling Emoji
meant like something was wrong in the
universe and I was I was determined to
fix this so um you know I was on this
email list and then a couple of like
maybe even like a couple weeks later I
got you know they they they kind of sent
out this note that's like hey who's
coming to the quarterly meeting and I
was like um I looked at the calendar I
looked at my schedule I was like oh I'll
be in like you know Silicon Valley that
time so I basically like rsvpd and I was
like I will be there and took um cow
train to an Apple building it's a legal
building in I think it was sunny Veil so
I just like show up and I don't know
what I was sort of expecting like with
like you know the Unicode I think maybe
thought it was going to be like a baby
Congress like you know like with a
little you know very formal seats people
with gabbles um that is not what I found
uh basically it is a it was a conference
room full of people who skewed wider
skewed older skewed Mal skewed engineers
and this is basically the room where it
happen so this is 2015 these were the
people who decided your Emoji um all
very nice and um there was you know one
one even had a daughter who had a sense
of humor and made him a shirt that said
shadowy Emoji Overlord um so I just kind
of listen to them debate things like
milk emoji and beans emoji and it just
seemed like not quite right to me that
like it would be uh This Global visual
language that were basically decided
decided by like a a small group of
people inside a conference room in
Silicon Valley so I decided to former
group called Emoji nation whose motto is
like Emoji by the people for the people
and it basically advocates for more kind
of Representative inclusive Emoji um you
know we we we we start with a
Kickstarter campaign uh dumpling Emoji
process trying to like you know write
the wrong in this world and uh made this
little cute video sort of advocating
dink for one of the most universal
crosscultural Foods in the world Georgia
has Kali Japan has giosa Korea has Mandu
Italy has ravioli Poland has barog
Russia has pelman Argentina has
empanadas Jewish people have kler China
has pot stickers Nepal and Tibet have
Momos yet somehow despite their
popularity there is no dumpling Emoji in
the standard set why is that emoji
exists for pizza tempora Sushi spaghetti
hot dog and now tacos which Taco Bell
takes credit for we need to write this
disparity dumplings are Global Emoji a
global isn't it time we brought them
together
oh yeah and while we're at it how about
an emoji for Chinese
takeout so uh I did put together a
dumpling Emoji proposal I wrote this uh
I remember Thanksgiving Day 2015 on a
plane and uh actually and we got it past
basically dumpling takeout box
Chopsticks and uh fortune cookie I have
to say I don't think fortune cookie
would have made it on its own merits but
it kind of like slid in on the clo tails
of the other ones um and so these were
the proposals as we submitted them and
then these are the ones that kind of uh
exist now on the Apple keyboard and I
have to say the dumpling looks really
really realistic um oddly realistic and
whereas like the fortune cookie is think
it's like a big fail because first of
all there's like it has no it has no Gap
it looks like a dead 3D Pac-Man so I'm
very
disappointed in uh the manifestation of
that but that's okay that's okay um and
so it's kind of interesting like what is
the process of getting an emoji um ped
and I will sort of walk you through it
so first of all you come up with your
idea right and then you kind of write
this proposal and then you submit it to
the Unicode Emoji subcommittee who then
kind of gives you comments and then
sends it back to you and you kind of go
around and around in the circle um and
when so these are things that we
consider so somewhere in there I also
like fought my way on to the Emoji
committee and then also became a vice
chair became a vice chair sort of a
extracurricular that's like completely
run a muck in my life um um so things
that matter uh popular demand is a
frequently requested Emoji um multiple
usages usages and meaning so that's
actually kind of very important for
something like you know certain animals
have meaning so we did you know sloth a
while ago and that also has not only the
literal meaning but sort of like um like
um connotations there are visually
distinctiveness it can be recognized so
this was a blocker for one of the uh
emojis that I have worked on before
which is cave which is kind of hard to
do I think you know meaning wise is
pretty good but it's really hard to get
a cave down in emoji sizes and then it
filling a gap completeness so a good
example for that is like for some reason
for many years we had Red Heart yellow
heart green heart blue heart purple
heart and uh no orange heart so so
somewhat so you know you would do the
rainbow but people would substitute the
pumpkin in so You' like you know have a
have a rainbow heart thing with a little
pumpkin stuck in the middle so orange
heart obviously should be added and give
a sense of completeness um and then
something else is existing vendor cap
cap compatibility and so a good example
for that was um many years ago what's
app decided to uh add the gender
non-binary emoji and then once it did
that then all the other kind of vendors
um jumped on um so what kind of knocks
out an emoji so too specific or narrow
so we'll often see that with like very
specific animals or a very specific
group it's redundant so one
year oh my God who makes that Butterball
Butterball makes the turkeys Butterball
submitted um a an emoji proposal that
was like a cooked turkey but we already
had a live turkey so it seem kind of
redundant have both like a cooked turkey
for Thanksgiving and a live turkey so so
not visually discernible um this is a
struggle for things like I don't my
friends have kind of proposed
kimchi kimchi is is really hard on emoji
sizes for many reasons and part of that
but part of that tension is because it's
not visually discernable then there are
no logos Brands deities or celebrities
so no Nike swish no McDonald's M and
then this is one that we kind of decided
in the last uh year or so which is no
more flags flags are a very complicated
thing um and as a result Unico does not
want to be in the business of deciding
what is a country or not a country uh so
like you know when you get a proposal
from like Kurdistan you're like yeah so
right now the way that the Emoji flags
are decided is they kind of depend on
what the UN recognizes and then those
get passed down to the international
standards organization and then and then
Uno just does that like it does not want
to be in the business of kind of you
know geopolitical
Affairs um so once it comes out of the
subcommittee it goes to the full Unicode
technical committee UTC those were the
people that were in the room that I
showed you um and they vote once a year
basically to pass all the Emoji and
takes a while there's a lot of like
coordinating with the international
standards organization and like a lot of
working with the companies and
eventually it takes a long time but it
ends up on your on your devices and that
historically is taken about 18 to 24
months from when you put in the propose
to when you get it in it's going to be a
little bit longer um going forward
probably is my sense as we were're going
to Unicode has decided to sort of space
out some of the Unicode releases so yeah
Emoji Nation you know kind of has done
its thing so of the weird things is like
how did Unicode this like kind of
nonprofit organization based in Mountain
View California end up controlling this
like Global visual language um so a lot
of it has to start with has has to do
with the fact that emoji started in
Japan uh back in the late 1990s one of
the this set from dok 1999 is considered
is widely considered sort of like the
first like color Emoji set it has been
collected by the Museum of Modern Art
and um so these the Japanese telecom
companies would use
basically would have their own sets of
emoji and then they were different
companies so they would have different
sets so you could basically only send
these like visual characters with
someone who is on your same carrier so
it's like it's like basically equivalent
of if you were on like Verizon you can
only text people on Verizon with like
Emoji or if you were on um T-Mobile you
could only do that so at a certain point
they um decided they were they the Apple
and Google came into Japan they wanted
to start selling smartphones and they
realized that it was a hodgepodge of
systems and they wanted to unify it and
so in 2007 they went to unic code and
they're like okay help us unify the
Emoji um like kind of like basically all
the Emojis so that we have one standard
system and part of the reason is why
Unicode because Unicode basically has
this mission is to enable everyone
speaking every language on Earth to be
able to use your languages on computer
and smartphone so it basically unifies
um all written languages into one
ginormous set and that was not the case
actually when I was uh growing up there
was a point where like if you you were
Japanese on Apple that would be
different than Japanese on um dos or
like Chinese or Arabic so it drove
everyone crazy and they basically
decided um around the late 80s early
1990s that they were going to come up
with one standardized system that sort
of encoded all characters in in one
ginormous set so um there's three main
projects for Unicode if you care so one
is encoding characters including Emoji
now they're about 100,000 characters
aside assigned so that includes like
like Chinese Japanese Korean uh Arabic
cilic um actually all the hieroglyphics
all of the Emoji um a lot of things like
the Bitcoin symbol or like copy left or
whatever those all assigned were about
100,000 uh characters even those
languages that are basically out of use
so the other thing it does it creates
um localization resources so things
things so that you know like oh if
you're in this country this is this is
uh you're using the Euro or you're using
the pesos or something so there's a lot
of localization that is that data that
is needed depending on which um
geography you're using your device from
or like that you know you you know that
the time is used this way or the dates
are shown that way so that is called um
the common local data repository or cldr
as they call it and the other thing they
do is they kind of maintain libraries
for developers in order to do all um to
kind of so they are not building
everything from scratch and that is
called ICU so it's very funny cuz like
it's called cldr and then one day one of
our friends girlfriends made him this
thing which she called a seal deer
because whenever he talked about
cldr he thought he thought she thought
he was talking about seal deers so now
this is his little like mascot for like
Unicode related things so what is um how
does Unicode do this so it basically
asss code points and each code point is
a unique number assigned to each Unicode
character so uh face with tears of joy
can be written like this with a code
point or it can be written like this in
terms of decimal numbers and it can also
be written this in binary numbers so
these are all basically the same and the
key thing to know at least about Emoji
is that when your device if you're
talking your iPhone with um someone
who's on a laptop or an iPad or like um
an Android device it's not sending the
images back and forth it's sending just
a number back and forth and then locally
your phone or like your laptop decides
like oh this number correlates with
which image um in terms of our emoji
font and then pulls it up so this is
really key to know why different Emoji
look different on different
platforms so 2007 to 2010 it took about
three years but Unicode 6.0 came out
with a first our first little baby set
of emoji um and it just kind of hung out
there for a year like no one it wasn't
doing anything so 2011 though Apple
starts adding the emoji keyboard and it
it just like explodes like I feel like
in some ways Emoji are were not like
invented they were discovered they like
obviously touch something very very
Primal to um to like our human desire to
like communicate in like little colorful
glyphs on electronic devices and you
kind of have what's kind of really
interesting is like the ambiguity that
comes with what emoji kind of mean and
so one of the you know this one my
favorite emoji is sort of like an upside
down smiley face very very ambiguous
clearly very ambiguous because if you
start typing into Google like the top
hits are like what does it mean from a
guy what does it mean from a girl like
it's clearly something that a lot of
people are are using in like complex
situationships between each other so um
so so one of the fun things is who can
propose Emoji technically anyone can
anyone here can normal normal humans can
we have basically Google doc uh or
Google form that we throw up uh
historically between August sorry April
and August in the last two years um and
uh so this is one of our my our favorite
examples this is Ru aumed she was a
15-year-old Saudi Arabian girl who was
living in Vienna at the time that she
proposed the um hijab emoji and then you
know then she was like Time Magazine
like you know coolest teens she got like
a whole bunch of different things she
got into Harvard and Stanford and she
went to Stanford um and uh so this is a
PR we got then there was a group of
folks from Argentina who got the mate
Emoji kind of they you know similar
their national drink then we worked with
um there was a a nonprofit that really
wanted to like get a menstruation emoji
and so what they proposed to begin with
was like bloody underwear and I was just
like no no no so many different reasons
why this is a terrible Emoji uh but so
we did get blood drops so then you can
do Moon and blood drop or underwear and
blood drop there's a lot of different
ways actually it's really funny cuz I
was ping my friends beforehand what they
would use to indicate menstruation
before there you know there was a blood
drop so there was like red wine there
was like kind of that Rose um with the
like falling petal and then my favorite
is actually um my friend who used a
Japanese flag as a way to indicate that
she was having her
period so um one of the biggest
contributors this uh skin tone Emoji
appeared I think in 2015 it was amazing
it is and it was proposed by a mom
Katrina parrot she is a entrepreneur and
a mom who is just like at home one day
and her daughter comes home and is
like you know I wish there were emoji
that looked like me and her mom was like
that's great honey what's an emoji and
so she like me I guess Googled and just
figured out that uh Unicode controlled
emoji and she just came up with a
proposal saying we should not only have
the yellow you know skin tones at that
time everything was sort of Simpsons
yellow um it's really interesting to see
how race and like nationality are like
depicted in different parts of the world
so originally in Japan everyone was
yellow um but this these were the non
you know by default everyone was just
like like you know human or Japanese but
they had like a couple things that were
like not like one was you had a blonde
person so there's an emoji called like
blonde blonde woman or whatever that
represents all westerners okay so that
was one and then they have one that's
like an Indian guy with a turban so
that's supposed to represent Indian
people and then there's like a like a
guy with a little like um little hat
that's supposed to represent like
Chinese people so that was like that was
the view Japanese view of race which was
like default then you were I then you
were like blonde Western Chinese or
Indian and and that is all there was and
um obviously in the United States we
care a lot about race and then so she
came up with this system with five skin
tones um like just like normal people
some guy in Germany decided that he
wanted to do a a a face with one eyebrow
raised or as we call it the coar Emoji
um and oh this one's fun so woman's flat
shoe I have to say not highly used
statistically at this point but I really
kind of appreciate it because it was a
mom who was very offended that all
women's shoes had heels even the sandals
so this is her she had like three kids
at the time now is four she was very
fertile um and she also did um the women
women's flat okay she also did um um one
piece bathing suit because she was also
um offended by the fact that the only
kind of bathing suit you had was like
this like little itsy-bitsy polka dot
bikini thing which is not great if
you're like taking your six-year-old so
I have to say that got passed but like
it didn't go over like super well with
everyone um so you know unic Cod because
it's very public submits things for
comments and um we got this comment back
so one piece bathing suit why a person
want to indicate the use of swimwear
can't use existing bikini is this really
necessary what about a Victorian bathing
costume or a wet suit or water rings
this is like literally in in like uh the
records and like do not encode um and so
the person who did it's actually very
impressive he's actually the person who
created the middle finger emoji and
actually you ever seen the Vulcan Emoji
he he the Vulcan hand emoji he's
actually very active and I have to say
this is actually I think one of the more
impressive Emoji so so obviously
obviously we have a lot of active debate
um sometimes you get like whole
countries submitting so literally the
government of Finland as in like their
equivalent in the state department their
diplomacy kind of thing uh submitted a
proposal for SAA and um these were so
creepy and so
weird so much is wrong with this and but
I I I felt where they were coming from
first of all like they're naked they
have no they have club feet and so we
decided to help them we're like okay we
see where you're going with this let's
see if we can like help you like come up
you know like we had the spoon like
should there be like steam around them
like should they be naked or wearing a
tow towel it's like super like dicey but
we wanted to help them because it was
like literally a foreign government
coming from an Unicode advocating for
the sauna emoji on behalf of their ENT
country so then this is um is sort of
evolved into just basically person in
stey room which is which is the most
sort of like the PG version of sauna no
and there's no spoon they're all dressed
it's very odd but um so you can see the
evolution of what it started out what we
submitted and what it ended up so
there's a lot of like Evolution
throughout the entire process um and
like companies can submit Emoji
proposals too so Google actually worked
on this one I love this one okay so just
to give you some context as of 2015
there are many ways you could be or have
an occupation as a male on the Emoji
Keyboard right like like for example you
could be a police officer you could be a
detective you could be a Buckingham
Palace guard you could even be Santa
Claus like these are so many jobs that
you could have but if you were a woman
as of 2015 there were four things that
you could be you could be a princess you
could be a bride you could be a dancer
or you could be a Playboy Bunny these
were the sum total of all the
occupations that we can have so so we
there was sort of this movement at that
time there was like this like video on
YouTube that like went viral there was
like a New York Times op that was like
where are the women with professions so
um basically they came up with a set of
emoji for professions and what's nice is
not only did women have these
professions now men have them too so of
emoji Nation Emoji these are some of the
ones that we've worked on I think about
130 of the Emoji on your keyboard
probably came through touched our system
in in some way including I I have to say
uh microbe or virus I think I have the
opinion that every Emoji has its day
right like it might not be like today it
might not be next year but I have to say
virus was not doing anything then came
2020 and that was like such a good
moment for it um along with soap we had
also done soap so um you know among the
other emoji that we have worked on are
sari moon cake llama like uh teddy bear
there were no toys I felt really sad for
toys we have like giraffe um there was
Hut bubble te bubble tea was very
controversial actually I have to say it
kind we tried to slide it in originally
with the um takeout box and the
dumplings and people were not not having
it I understand that CU there's not a
lot like compared to like beer or wine
like bubble tea does not is not long
does not have a long history on this
planet um but I will say that um they
submitted again actually kind of
originally proposing that it was not
just bubble tea but but like a black
ball and milk and tea it was It was kind
of cool and I I have to say there was
definitely a generational divide between
like the Asian women who sit in that
room and are like this absolutely is a
thing that we consume like almost like
every week of our life and people who
are a little bit older who are like that
looks like a parfait how do you not know
that's a parfet and we're like we
absolutely know it is uh not a parfait
and so so it got in eventually so it
does sort of influence it kind of shows
like who is in the room influences you
know the decisions um that get made or
sometimes in the room now sometimes more
more likely in the zoom um I actually I
just say beaver Emoji if you see Beaver
Emoji that's one of one of the ones I'm
most proud of so that is actually
co-authored by a professor here at
Harvard um who is both lesbian and was
married to a woman from Canada so it was
very important to her to get um the
beaver Emoji passed and she promised me
it would always be the first line of her
bio so and indeed if you go to her
Twitter handle uh it's like Joan Donovan
creator of the Beaver Emoji comma is
headed research at the shoren scene
Center at the Harvard Kennedy School
It's Kind it's pretty impressive um and
then we did greens actually greens was
really interesting because people this
was also like a generational cultural
thing people were like why do we need
greens we have salad and I was like
we're Chinese we don't eat raw greens
cuz like you don't know where it's been
or if it's clean so we cook our greens
so salad is not something that we have
So eventually I got my greens and um so
that was kind of fun and then so these
are some of the people who sort of have
contributed to our little Emoji Nation
things including a number of Native
Americans who help get feather so why do
I care so part of it is because I'm
Chinese I grew up speaking Chinese and
English at the same time and it's really
interesting to see like Chinese and
English characters in terms of emoji and
Chinese together right so this is fire
you have like Fire characters and now
you have the Emoji things and it's kind
of It kind of shows that there is a
longevity in The Human Experience of
something that was designed 4,000 years
ago as the same visual cues in the human
experiences as now so mouth Tre tree
Moon Sun you can mix and match them
which is super fun um so you know two
trees kind of make a forest oops sorry
oh well okay then the um Moon and Sun
together means bright which I like um I
like this one so if you stop and you
think about this so this is a basically
a pig under a roof and what does that
mean
it does not mean Farm as you might think
it um it actually means home or family
so in the Chinese kind of structure and
outlook on The View it's like where you
keep your pigs is actually where your
home is and what your farm is um so it
gets kind of weird in all kinds of ways
so one of my favorite radicals so this
character means woman uh KN
and as I was learning Chinese you kind
of notice like how it shows up so so
this is a woman underneath a roof and
you're like oh it means mom or wife or
or like whatever like home um it does
not it means peace because things are at
home when the woman is or things are at
peace when the woman is at home
underneath a roof which I always thought
was a little bit odd um then there is
also uh woman plus child so you're like
oh and actually specifically Boy Child
the connotation there is a little
unclear so you're like a woman plus
child family mom you know whatever um it
is not it means good so the standard for
goodness in ancient China was a woman
who had a male child child so that kind
of kind of just like kind of irked me um
growing up and then you know three women
together means evil which is like very
like
MCB this character means greed this
character means slave this marriage
let's see I think this one is jealousy
and this means means adultery or
betrayal so like definitely not loving
the way women were P you know portrayed
um on the emoji keyboard so uh in case
you're wondering we just came out with a
kids book called had emoji that kind of
Compares emoji and uh Chinese and I
think I I think they sent a bunch of
books so that you guys can do some kind
of contest some like later on with cs50
um so but the mixing and matching is
really interesting right for example the
skin tones are actually the same yellow
character plus a layer of skin tone on
top of this so I kind of took my lessons
from Chinese in terms of seeing how
things can be binded so there's
something you should know about which is
zge this is also an invisible emoji
character it stands for zero with Joiner
and it was actually originally created
mostly for I think Arabic where you
would you would basically kind of force
something to have like be in the
beginning of of a word or an end of the
word by kind of having this like
invisible character so the rainbow flag
for example is actually a rainbow plus
the white flag
um and we we could have all kinds of fun
combinations if you look at polar bear
it actually is if you have an older
device or it breaks apart it is bear
plus snow which is really cute it was
originally I had bear plus white and
then we decided that bear plus snow made
a lot more sense so uh another one this
is new I I think if you guys should have
it if you've updated your phones in the
last year or so so mending heart is
heart plus
Band-Aid um um what is this one oh this
is interesting um there was a
breastfeeding woman for a long time and
people felt like there was not gender
par was actually really interesting all
the people who wrote it and were like I
want to I want to be a dad showing that
I'm holding my baby why is there only a
woman holding my baby so so we kind of
created a whole set so this is man plus
bottle Tada um and so this is and all of
these occupations are actually often
times a woman plus like you know the
fried egg or like um a school or a
tractor and that's how you got the
occupations if you if you if you send an
emoji over into an older system
sometimes you'll it'll break apart so
one of my kind of favorite kind of
contributions in this in this world is
interracial couple Emoji which we did
with um Tinder which is super fun
because then you could have you know
different couples that are and and like
so many combin this is like this is a
fun if you guys ever have to do a
combinatoric test um this is really fun
because you have two genders plus a
third like gender plus two people plus
five skin tones plus yellow like how
many Emoji couples can you come come up
with when you introduce this Factor so
this is um and underneath it it's just a
wige sequence it's like two people
standing together that are like glued
together now this actually gets
interesting from a cs-50 perspective
because in many cases even though you
only see one character underneath the
hood depending on how your system works
they're counting each one of these as an
individual character so your string
length actually might be five and
instead of one and this this kind of
became a problem with things like
Twitter where things had a hard skin um
length so gender inclusivity um is
actually one of the things that we've
been dealing most with um in the last
couple years so it's kind of interesting
if you think about both what a pictorial
language looks like versus the
abstractness of a of a spoken language
so because you know we had boy and we
had
girl but there was no way to say a
generic child right like if you were on
you wanted to say child you had to pick
a boy or a girl but not a way to say
like just some little person and that's
really key cuz in English at least there
is no gender implied by
child um so how do we mimic that and it
also is key for something like doctor
right doctor and teacher those are those
have don't have gender implied but when
we have them on on the Emoji Keyboard
you to pick a male teacher or um you
know a a a female doctor or whatnot so
there was actually uh a guy at Adobe who
can considers himself non-gender binary
also The Man Behind the orange um the
orange heart he fought and got basically
uh the first three non-gender uh
non-gender binary emojis so child adult
and old older adults so those are
creative and then we started having to
propagate them through actually all the
occupations so these are the gender
neutral versions of many of those um but
then uh we got into this whole thing
where every emoji that had a gender
originally had to be mirrored so
originally we had bearded man and then
we're like okay well we actually have to
get bearded woman so that is on your
keyboard there is pregnant woman there
is now pregnant man which is interesting
um there is you know woman in a bridal
gown there's now man in a bridal gown um
and then there were ones that actually
had to be created that were neither man
or woman so this is a mer person so
there was merman there was mermaid and
there was M person it was really
interesting to figure out like how do
you draw a gender neutral M person like
a bunch of them in the beginning
actually had the arms crossed around
sort of the chest um Monarch so there
was prince and princess and now there is
monarch and one of my favorite actually
is there was Santa Claus and there was
Mrs Claus and now there's MX Claus like
the name of this character literally in
Unicode is MX claw so I feel like it's
sort of like a very official enshrining
of gender non biner in like the world um
not everyone loved it New York Post did
not love this that they like you know
we're we're cing into like Emoji woke
Wars um so some Emoji stats for you this
is very fascinating this is sort of like
the Gen the General Distribution by far
the single emoji that used more than
anything else is the face with tears of
joy about 10% of all Emoji scent is that
one character and then number two is
heart red heart and then it kind of goes
down so um there's a frequency of emoji
use these this is sort of done by um
order magnitude so one is half of two
two is half of one so it's really
interesting it's a very very steep drop
off after the first couple um in case
you ever want to go onto the the Emoji
kind of Unicode website you can you too
can see all the frequency things so I
think it's really funny so basically
it's green going this way it increased
in usage between 2019 and uh 2021 and
it's red going this way it drop and so
pleading face which is a relatively new
emoe you just sort of shut up on the
charts um and whereas actually like
smiling face with heart eyes
like kind of kind of slipped which is
interesting so we just closed our Emoji
proposal round for 2022 these were sort
of the breakdowns people love submitting
Smileys and food and beverages animals
and nature da da da I don't I mean these
are very googly colors um so what is the
future of emoji I will um I will tell
you because we just had a meeting two
weeks ago so I can now publicly talk
about it so historically there was this
whole idea like Unico doesn't want to be
in the world of like encoding glyphs for
like devices everywhere like there was
very controversial when it started doing
that because mostly what Unicode used to
do was you take an existing language
could be dead you know and then it would
just take it and digitize it right it
took languages that existed and just
digitize them and uh then when it kind
of wandered into Emoji World Suddenly
It's like deciding what deserves to be
like an emoji decides to be digitized so
um trying to get kind of get out of it
and they have proposals over time where
it's like oh maybe we should like come
up with a a way to just send pictures
back and forth where you you it's a
fixed picture and you like use a hash so
that you know like we would look at the
picture and then like go do a lookup
somewhere like that did not go over well
then there was actually a really
interesting proposal I kind of like uh
didn't go over well which is using
something called the qid which is in
Wiki in the Wikipedia world so in
Wikipedia World items all have uh
numbers across the different language
Wikipedia so Obama human Earth they will
have an ID number so that the page in
English and the page in German the page
in Chinese all know that they're
pointing to the same thing so the
question so one idea came up like why
don't we use the numbering system so we
can use like Eiffel Tower in you know
see the number and then like oh people
know like oh you're trying to say Eiffel
Tower that did not go over well so those
are both both of those proposals seem
dead as of yet um and it's too bad cuz
and you'll see kind of what's happening
okay so what's coming in 22 so these are
the Emoji that I actually sort of
thought they would be on your phones by
now but cuz we're in mid November and
they usually update early November so
three more Hearts people love hearts
like uh wing blackbird Goose Birds also
purple flowers jellyfish moose face
donkey donkey was a little bit late for
the kind of Elections um Ginger peep pod
Wireless cond shaking face um folding
hand pan that one was interesting cuz
when people first proposed it they
proposed it as like an electric fan and
that didn't like who knows what electric
fans will look like in 100 years because
the thing is Once An Emoji always an
emoji they never retire so they're
always looking for things that have a
long visual longevity floppy disc did
not actually do that so there's always
like we don't want another floppy disc
um and then hairpick is interesting so
there was a whole debate about how to
convey um like afro African hair like
the the curly hair that they introduced
a couple years ago was supposed to do
that and most of the vendors actually
have it in a sort of Afro way except for
Apple so there's a lot of complaints but
um hairpick was sort of a an interesting
way it means both comb but also has sort
of an interesting historic connotation
and it's been around for about 2,000
years uh a couple music things maracus
and flute uh Beyond 2022 one of the
things that's going to die oops can I go
back no I can't oh well uh we're going
to retire the the family Emoji um they
didn't go over so well there were so
many of them combinatorically if you had
all the everything in in uh you know all
the race all the races all because you
wanted to have skin tones because you
didn't want to imply that families can
only be one race it was such an ordeal
uh essentially we're all like no one
uses them and there's so many and it's
like the fonts like in terms of the load
is like too large so they're just going
to make them all into like basically
little like bathroom symbol Type U folks
um so I think that is those will
disappear what what's actually really
interesting about the family Emoji is
they had gay when they introduced the
family they had gay family emoji and the
Russian government went berserk and
actually you can Google this in 2015
you'll see a bunch of articles about
like the Russian government considering
it homosexual propaganda to Youth and
there was a big debate about whether or
not they were going to ban Apple devices
and what so you can see a lot of the
media coverage from that time but I
thought it was really interesting how
upset a national government can get
about little pictures on your phone um
another thing that's going to that's on
the agenda as of you know a couple of
weeks ago is directionality in terms of
emoji so as you know most emojis kind of
just flip one way or another and the
reason why it matters is because not all
languages run in the same direction so
for example Arabic so we are used to
left to right but a lot of languages go
right to left um so and this kind of It
kind of changes the meaning of emoji for
example right to left I send this a lot
to my friends when I'm going flying from
the Bay Area to New York um if you do it
from left to right however that is what
it looks like so it looks like um you
know you're in NE Bay but the plane is
still going that you know kind of up and
to the right and then now it looks like
you're going from New York to the Bay
Area the other place is like oh it's
it's a girl and she's running really
fast right uh that is left to right to
left in our world wait left to right
sorry sorry that was that's that's
supposed to be left to right and in here
it would be she's like behind like
pollution or something like that so
sorry about so so an example this is
actually in The Proposal like in one
case if it's left or right you're
running away from a line of cars and the
other one it's a warning to not run
behind car fumes so they are trying to
figure out like how do we mirror a bunch
of the Emoji um but the LA the main
thing that I think sort of I don't know
when it's going to happen I'm really
hopeful is going to happen is trying to
come up with a system that supports
little stickers in line that don't need
Unicode so this is like slack or on um
twitch you can embed little pictures on
in line and all all all the vendors have
to get together and agree to come up
with a standard way to do that they have
not yet come up with that but that is
sort of one of the ways that unic coded
like want it wants to back away from
actually being like a global regulator
for like little colorful glyphs and so
if you ever need to reach me um on in my
emoji world you can find me um Jenny
EmojiNation org there will
be um the it will be actually a while I
think before we see a next generation of
emoji showing up in it used to be like
every year they would get new code
points it might be a little bit less
than every year now as they work on
things like directionality over time so
that uh if anyone has questions you can
ask questions you can find me afterwards
I think I've I feel like there's
supposed to be some some hubub right now
about maybe maybe
um microphones but maybe not but maybe
I'm just done and if if there are
questions or if David is around I'm
happy you know he can I'm I'm happy to
to answer any questions that folks have
yes hi yes I was wondering what were
your thoughts on the
emo so the question is what are my
thoughts on the Emoji Movie you're
talking about the Sony animated one yes
okay my thought on that is it is better
than a 6% rating on um Rotten Tomatoes
would lead you to believe so that's my
one thought and my my next thought is
that um that was a rush job from an
animation perspective that was that was
was about 18 months of whereas a typical
animated movie takes four years so in my
spare time I also produce movies and
documentaries so one thing that is key
to know
about about movies and animated movies
and this is very important they take a
very long time but you can always fix it
because you haven't shot anything and a
very good example of that is I assume
you guys have seen Frozen if you haven't
seen you seen of the age you would have
seen Frozen um I do not understand like
how huge and a phenomenon or why it was
such a huge phenomenon but
um they actually did a original cut of
Frozen and it did so I don't know you
guys know the the Eye the the sort of
Snow Queen thing but she's like super
dark and like not fun and like kind of
evil and like not someone you want to
like get behind as a character so they
actually did sort of a rough cut of that
of Frozen and they came out of that with
um it's just storyboarding and they're
like that is not good and they killed it
so they were like we can't go with this
and then started from scratch more or
less again starting with the song um Let
It Go which is actually written by a kid
from my elementary school Bobby Lopez or
co-written by Bobby Lopez um I also
actually fun fact I also went I would
took the school bus with uh Lyn mmel
Miranda so I was a fourth grader when he
was like a kindergartener so we had a
very musical Elementary School in New
York City but the thing is they could
fix it because they had enough time and
have enough money not like movies where
you shoot humans much harder to fix so
you have the footage that you have and
you can do little pickups but you can't
fix it so essentially what happened in
that case I think um it's 18 months and
it could have gotten better and a lot of
the movies that you see with Pixar like
it's very it's actually sort emotionally
similar to the movie called inside out
and uh but inside they just have more
time and so it's better so as opposed to
18 months which is not long enough to
make a animated movie good but uh the
other fun thing is is it was the it it
was so weird cuz they sold sponsorships
it was like like oh my God here comes
the Bots and the malware let's go into
Dropbox and protect ourselves and was so
I think that it got a lot of like bad
kind of um kind of uh vibes from the
from the press for doing things like
that but from a kids perspective it's
it's fine I think if um I don't know
that I would like put into my top 10 of
animated pictures but it's better than
6% on Rotten Tomatoes
and then actually if you guys ever care
we we have done uh I did a documentary
about Emoji so and all the people that
create helped create emoji and uh we did
a cs50x movie night I think during the
pandemic was it during the pandemic
everything sort of like blurred together
but it was during the pandemic yeah Are
we more questions yes um I wanted to
know you mentioned that one of the
criteria for
AC do or there's demand
yeah yeah that's a very good question
yeah so the question is one of the
propos one of our criterias of of um
getting an emoji accepted is to sort of
to demonstrate demand and how do we
demonstrate demand and I would say in a
in a pretty um clumsy way actually at
this point so the main thing that you
have in our in our current proposal
process is we have um a median Emoji
which is elephant so elephant is like if
you stack ranked all the emoji for
popularity elephant is like right there
in the middle and it's also a concept
that's like universally understood
across all
languages so um elephant shows up
somewhere between 500 million and 700
million in Google search results like if
you type it into a laptop you'll see you
know elephant 500,000 uh 500 million
search results and generally you're
you're trying to when you're comparing
your term to elephant you want to see
very roughly how many Google search
results B search results sometimes
Instagram so actually something that was
really surprising to me was someone
proposed hummingbird I think hummingbird
is uh a good proposal and um but if you
look at Hummingbird it's only like 21
million in terms of the stat so which I
thought was like very surprisingly low
so that's one of the main ways that we
kind of we kind of see like is it also
visually used and all of that yeah any
other questions are we good I didn't
even need my water or anything oh can I
take I'm going to take a picture I'm
going to take a picture for because now
you guys are actually human and not
Muppets so I'm very very excited about
this so I will send this to like my
block mates and be like I just lectured
at CS you know in Sanders Theater my
thanks to Jenny Lee thank
you yeah you can stay up here for give
me one
second
so if up until now thought it would be
appropriate to toss this up on the board
if up until now you've not yet gotten
cs50 stress ball on the way out please
do grab one we got some extras as well
off to the side but I would also keep in
mind back in week zero where again we
began we asked you to categorize
yourselves as to whether you are among
those less comfortable those more
comfortable or those somewhere in
between uh please know now that you are
officially all some uh please know now
that you are all officially among those
more comfortable and indeed even though
a couple of more Milestones await we
cannot wait to see what you accomplish
with your final projects in the meantime
as always this is and now this was
cs50
[Laughter]
[Music]
Mr when
I in CS I'll say truth be told I thought
i' be real coding hero because I did
so it picked up so fast turn out that
harder scratch hell world and
goodby
[Applause]
[Music]
because
Mr I was on
the trying so hard not fall behind
attending section and wanting a stuck in
the in void of my
computer to pyth in why on because this
is
[Music]
s Mr s we completed
JavaScript sequ CSS
and every language our to reset don't
[Music]
get again I repli
obviously because
cie
[Applause]
because
[Music]
all right so this is cs50 my name is
David May and this is Harvard
University's introduction to the
intellectual Enterprises of computer
science and the Art of programming and
this of course is our special family
weekend wherein not only are cs50's own
students here in the audience but also
some family members as well now you're
showing up in the semester a little bit
late we've just tackled week eight which
is really our ninth week since computer
scientists start counting from zero so
we've done a whole lot of work over the
past few weeks as you might have heard
via emails or text messages home
including a language known here as binar
so on the screen here of course is a lot
of zeros and ones and suffice it to say
let me sum up the past nine weeks with
this is what's going on underneath the
hood but of course today we thought we'd
make things a little more accessible a
little more broadly applicable and
indeed our Focus today will not be on
what these patterns of zeros and ones
represent which in astute eye might
notice are replicated visually with
these light bulbs being in a pattern on
and off and as your child might have
hinted uh before class or perhaps now
this might very well spell a word up to
eight characters long because you can
encode even in the real world things
digital too but today we'll focus on
things much more high level this notion
of cyber security like our the security
of our data our privacy of our systems
particularly on the internet nowadays
because presumably all of us are
carrying Technologies around in our
pocket using laptops and desktops every
day and so the goal today is to
stipulate that this is what's going on
underneath the hood but let's solve some
problems at a higher level so that your
homework when you go back to wherever
you're visiting from can actually be to
apply some of today's Lessons Learned so
with that said perhaps the most common
familiar defense uh of one's systems and
data phone and laptops and desktops
would just be these simple passwords
unfortunately you and I are frankly as
humans not all that good at choosing
passwords and this is in itself a
relatively weak form of Defense even
though each of us has dozens hundreds of
passwords nowadays or at least dozens or
hundreds of accounts Maybe fives or tens
of dozens of passwords indeed if you're
in the habit of reusing passwords we'll
see today probably among our first
Lessons Learned so for instance if we
look back at the past year 2021 thanks
to security researchers who take a look
at data that has been hacked or leaked
online by way of public databases we
have a sense as computer scientists of
what the most popular or equivalently
what some of the worst passwords are
that you and I are choosing for our
system so as of this past year according
to one measure the most commonly used
password in systems everywhere was 1 2 3
4 5 6 all right number two password in
our top 10 here list was only slightly
longer 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 after that we
took a turn in the other direction 1 2 3
4 five alone after that got a little
more interesting quiry which might sound
pretty cryptic but not if you look down
at your US keyboard and it's the top
leftand row of the keys on a an American
keyboard so also not all that hard uh
perhaps not surprisingly uh a little
disconcertingly number five was
password meanwhile number six returns us
to digits 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 after that
really less effort 111 111 uh after that
a little more variation but not all that
much 1 two 3 one two 3 after that it's
getting even less interesting 1 2 3 4 5
6 7
890 and then lastly topping the list is
just 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 so this is not a good
top 10 list to be on so among today's
first takeaways is if you see your
password on the screen like you didn't
make the list in a good way this means
hundreds thousands millions of other
people probably have that password of
yours now in of itself that's not
necessarily worrisome because I don't
know who has these passwords in a room
as large as this but just intuitively
why is this a bad thing either parent or
child welcome to raise a hand here why
might this be
intuitively yeah access to it so access
to it like I mean we literally as
computer scientists now have a database
of really common passwords and your your
thoughts password and can just find it
out quickly yeah you can just find it
out quickly I mean you could imagine
trying to guess someone's password by
just typing in random letters random
numbers random words but not if you have
a top 10 list like the the adversaries
in the world might as well just start
with this list now you'll notice that
even absent from this are slight
variants like some of you might be
thinking I'm not on the list cuz I do
something clever like I use an
exclamation point for the number one or
a three for an e or a five for an S and
based on the smiles in the room right
now you're not all that clever it turns
out because other people are smiling too
which is to say that an adversary can
take those same fistic that you might
think are making things more secure by
just tweaking some letters to numbers or
vice versa but if you're doing it and
other people are doing it the bad guys
so to speak are going to be doing it as
well so unfortunately when it comes to
passwords better is longer and random
and really unguessable but that's not
what most of us have in fact case in
point on our phones whether you have an
Android device or an iPhone nowadays you
know odds are you have something
relatively simplistic protecting it if
you have anything at all but at least
Apple and Google are pretty good at
least nudging us to choose these kinds
of passcodes now and a four-digit
passcode is quite common nowadays and so
here's where we have an opportunity
thanks to uh the URL that you saw on the
screen earlier to conjecture as a group
just how long might it take an adversary
someone out there who's out to get us or
get one of us uh how long might it take
an adversary to figure out your phone's
4digit passcode this is a cs50 is on
Carter Carter if we could switch over
and poll the audience here if you take
out your phone or laptop whatever device
you might have used a few minutes ago to
scan that QR code or to visit that same
URL you can see these questions on your
browser and if you can't that's fine
we'll share some aggregate data
nonetheless but you should have an
opportunity to tap one of your answers
and we'll give folks a few more
seconds if you'd like to play along at
home and here in just a
moment probably have many people
reporting but why don't we go ahead and
take a look at some percentages it looks
like most of you 67% are proposing just
a few seconds so that's not all that
good news if it's a four-digit passcode
some of you are hoping it's a few
minutes uh 8% are hoping a few hours
four more than 4% of you are really
hoping perhaps it's a few days well
let's actually consider how we can
answer this question and make today not
just conceptual but a little
quantitative too and see if we can't
slap some numbers on questions like
these so ultimately you can make more
informed decisions with your system
security so for instance when it comes
to four digigit passcodes rather than
just consider how secure it is well
let's make it a more precise question
like what are the forms of attack well
the simplest attack might be just
someone grabbing your phone be it in
your family or maybe at Starbucks or the
airport or the like and just starting
all possible combinations maybe 00000000
then 00001 and 00002 we could maybe
automate this a little bit so for
instance I might potentially be able to
do something like uh roboticize this
here let me go ahead and full screen a
quick video here that's just going to
paint a picture in just a moment on the
screen of how if we're a really clever
adversary and know how to build things
well at least maybe we could automate
some of that process so here's an
Android phone on a counter here's a very
simple tripod and a little touch device
robotically doing all of that hacking
for you starting at 0000 Z probably all
the way up to 9999 now that too wasn't
necessarily all of that all that fast
but at least you the adversary can step
away and doesn't actually have to be
bothered with the time involved the cost
involved in actually hacking that
particular device well let's go one
level deeper a little more interestingly
and consider here um the how much much
time really this so-called Brute Force
attack would take and that's actually a
term of art much like in yester year
when maybe there was a battering ram
trying to brute force their way into a
castle or something like that a Brute
Force attack digitally is just someone
trying manually all possible codes or
maybe robotically trying all possible
codes but generally automating the
process in some way to go through all
possibilities well if you've got for
instance um a 4digit passcode let's ask
maybe a follow-up question here not how
long will take but how many possible
4digit passcodes are there because then
maybe we can do some quick math and if
every passcode takes me a second or a
few milliseconds or the like then I
think we can try to extrapolate from
that whether the first answer was
seconds or minutes or days or hours or
something else so how many four-digit
passcodes are possible if you take out
your same device it should have just
changed automatically if it doesn't seem
to have maybe reload your browser with
some menu option and then tap in here
how many four digigit passcodes are
possible four total 40 99,999 10,000 or
unsure is okay
too so let's see we'll give you a few
more moments how many four digigit
passcodes are possible and shall we
reveal the results so now it looks like
uh a a few of you uh 2% of you are
saying just four passcodes 40 99,999
there's definitely some contention here
and 6% are un sure well how do we wrap
our minds around this well let's just
kind of do this real simply here let me
switch back over to doing a bit of math
and if we have here 10 possibilities for
each digit if there's four digits each
digit can be 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 nine so
that's 10 possibilities so if you think
about the number of permutations that's
10 possibilities for the first digit
times 10 for the next time 10 to the for
the next times 10 for the next and so if
we do that out 10 * 10 * 10 * 10 or 10
the 4th there are indeed as 66% of you
uh found uh 10,000 possibilities and so
now we can kind of work backwards and
decide how long is it going to take for
an adversary to hack into this phone
because if it's one attack one guess per
second well that's going to map out to
10,000 seconds but maybe not if the
adversary isn't a roboticist or a human
what if they're like at a software
programmer someone who's taken even a
class introductory like cs50 and learned
a little bit of programming well a
little bit frighteningly it's not all
that hard to hack into systems if you
just know how to code to and really have
the computer do your work for you so in
fact let me go ahead and change over to
another screen on my computer here um
this is different for students in the
group from vs code this is just a black
and white version of it that we've used
briefly in the past and I'm just going
to go ahead and create a program called
crack.pie to crack something just
technically means to figure out what it
is figure out a password in this case
and dop means I'm going to use a
programming language that we here in
cs50 have been dabbling in in the past
couple of weeks with more to come next
week as well so it turns out and you
need not understand each of these lines
of code if I want to try maybe
generating all 10,000 possible codes I'm
not going to bother with a robot I've
got all these cables coming out of my
computer and odds are one of them is a
USB cable or a lightning cable surely we
could figure out how to connect like
laptop or desktop to phone and just like
automate the process nowadays by just
sending all of the numbers into the
phone until one uh unlocks the trick
just like in the movies or TV well in
Python I could write a program that does
this as follows I can import so to speak
all of the decimal digits 0 through n
and this for students in the room is
just a slightly better version of typing
out 10 different numbers manually I can
also import from a library so to speak
called iter tools for iteration tools
which means to do something again and
again I can import a function called
Product which means the cross product
like combine this with this some number
of times and then it's just two more
lines of code I can use what's called a
loop and programming so for every
passcode in the cross product of all 10
of those digits repeated a total of four
times let me go ahead and rather than
bother connecting my phone and hacking
my own phone let me just print out every
one of those 10,000 codes on the screen
and we'll see how fast the hacker could
do this let me go ahead and print and
with an asterisk which is a little trick
to format it nicely I'm going to print
out each of those passcodes and that's
it four lines of code maybe 40 seconds
of talking but maybe really four seconds
of code if I actually did this without
the audience and now let me go ahead and
save the file and I'm going to run as we
do every in class of late python of
crack.pie and when I hit enter I should
see on the screen all 10,000
possibilities from 000000 to 9999 so
let's see is it a few seconds minutes
hours or days done so barely even
seconds plural if that so that should be
a little disconcerting because all that
adversary needs to do is grab your phone
off the counter plug in a cable and boom
they're done like there's no ticking
clock or worries as in the movies or TV
that maybe you're going to come into the
room you don't need that much of a
window of time so what would be better
than this well let's consider what our
options might be if we don't want to
just use four-digit passcode some of you
indeed might have better passcodes than
that and maybe you use four letter
passcodes instead so A through Z maybe
uppercase and lowercase that starts to
make things a little more interesting so
should we pull this question too if we
upgrade from four digits to just four
letters English letters a through z
uppercase and lowercase why don't we go
ahead and pull the grip here and ask how
many four letter passcodes are there
instead so this time the range starts at
four still not the right answer though
this time how many four-letter passcodes
are
possible not just just take a couple
more
seconds
all right almost a couple hundred
responses in already few more
seconds
and why don't we go ahead and reveal now
the answers which are Okay so we've
solved a couple problems at least so we
well we well okay someone's just messing
with us now all right so it looks like
most of you 76% of you have claimed it's
7 million plus possibilities so that's
encouraging cuz that's a whole order of
magnitude more than before well let's
figure out how we might do this
mathematically so if we've got 26
lowercase 26 uppercase that's 52
possibilities now for each of those four
digits so that's 52 times itself four
times which indeed either off the top of
your head a good guess a calculator on
the same device you're using right now
indeed gives us 7 million instead well
what might be slightly better than that
well maybe four characters and this
indeed is what your Macs PCS and phones
are urging us to do nowadays not just
numbers not just letters but like really
annoying punctuation so it really looks
cryptic not just to the adversary but
also to you and me unfortunately and
that's the downside but here now we have
a mental model and really a
computational framework via which we can
evaluate the security of these and I'll
go ahead and spoil some of the math here
if we've got 52 uh letters of the
alphabet uppercase and lowercase 10
digits and if I count them out on my
keyboard about 32 punctuation symbols in
typical English grammar that actually
gives us 94 possibilities now which is
up from 52 which is up from 10 so now
we're really moving and now that would
give us 78 million possibility so
another order of magnitude now it's
still going to be relatively fast
because you know what I can actually do
this let me go back into my code here
let me reopen the same program and I can
point out just how easy it is to make
these changes instead of importing
digits as before I can import as your uh
child might know asky letters which are
a through z uppercase lowercase and I
can just change this here asky letters
and so this was that first version where
we just changed to letters let me now
rerun the code and instead of seeing
numbers we'll see letters flying across
the screen and if I walk over here to
the screen we'll see that by the time I
get here we're halfway through the
entire alphabet lowercase if I now start
walking away I think yep we're already
done now with uppercase as well if I
upgrade this slightly further let's go
ahead and take it one more level and
perhaps do let's say ask letters and
digits and punctuation and this would be
the pythonic way to say that and I'm
going to add to those letters those same
digits those same punctuation symbols
let me shrink my font just so the code
still fits on the screen and what we now
have is with a two seconds of changes a
program that if I run this version
whoops without the typographical error
this is what we call in cs50 a bug so
now we run the same this is what we call
in cs50 a second
bug
punctuation okay this is where I cross
my fingers okay so now it's going to be
a little hard to see as it flies across
the screen but you probably are seeing
glimpses of some weird punctuation
characters as well and I won't waste our
time trying to talk through this because
this is going to take longer we're still
in the lower case I'm still over here
already we've not even gotten to n now O
then P so this is going to run longer
but let's end with one final question on
the security of all these systems I'm
going to cancel that by hitting contrl C
on my keyboard and let's ask the
question instead if we use eight
character passwords so twice as many
characters but even that is not terribly
long right this is eight characters
alone on the stage eight characters
using letters numbers and punctuation
might be better let's do one final vote
here if we could on your same device how
many eight character possibilities are
there now
for these
passcodes and now for didn't even make
the list this
time all right few more seconds about
100 responses so
far how about we go ahead and Carter if
you would't mind let's reveal the
results based on the vote a pretty
decent spread here although the
quadrillions are quickly buzzing in and
they're contending with the others here
looks like 44% of you said quintilian
34% said quadrillion and this time for
the first time uh you overbid so indeed
if we go back to the math here at least
the majority overbid if we have eight
character passcodes that gives us 94
times itself 8 times or 94 to the eth
power and in fact that gives us roughly
6 quadrillion 95 trillion 689 Bill 385
mil 410,000 and
86 possible passcodes now what does that
mean well the adversary's algorithm the
step-by-step code that they write to try
to hack into your phone is no different
and honestly if your passcode is eight
characters long but there're zeros
00000000000000 you're no more secure
fundamentally you really want to be
somewhere in The Sweet Spot of that
massive range of values so that if the
adversary tries this Brute Force attack
just running through all possibilities
they will eventually reach your passcode
just mathematically it will be there
hopefully though well maybe not
hopefully you and I and they will be
gone from this world because that much
time will have passed and if we fact if
we do out the math here uh this number
of seconds for instance is long past uh
when uh uh we will uh no longer be here
so that's the sort of measure is we
don't sort of fundamentally change the
equation for the adversary it's still
the same risk it's still the same attack
but you significantly drive down the
probability of success on their part or
conceptually you drive up the cost to
the adversary and indeed even in the
physical world this is true you just
want your passcode in the digital world
really to be better than someone else's
because you want someone else's passcode
to be the one that the adversary does
something with with just like in the
physical world even though it's a bit uh
uncomfortable to consider your house
doesn't need to be 100% secure and
indeed it's difficult to make it such
there's always going to be a a point of
weakness maybe it's that window the door
or something like that but if your home
is more secure than the next door home
just probabilistically you are more
secure you're not secure and indeed any
website you see down the road that says
we are secure because we do X Y or Z
like that's nonsense security is really
about comparisons and Val ating things
if quantitatively relative to some other
system relative to some other code so
what's the takeaway here well hopefully
a non-trivial number of you we'll go
home this weekend on Monday and change
at least one passcode um but there's
going to be a trade-off here and we talk
about this all the time in cs50 anytime
we improve something we pay some price
in time and performance and cost
somewhere else so what's the downside
then of this advice that you should use
minimally eight character
passcodes why might you want to say nay
and not do
this say again you have to remember you
have to remember it right and so here
there's sort of some sociology there's
some human behavior you know some of you
might have colleagues if you're working
in the real world at least back in
healthier times when you had colleagues
with desks and cubicles and there's
probably one person in the office with
like a Post-It note on their monitor
with their passcode you know it's a bit
of a cyber security offense but it's
also a sort of real world side effect
maybe of corporate policies that aren't
really calibrated for human behavior so
we'll see if there's some other defenses
and indeed let me propose that we talk
briefly about one that actually tends to
kick in automatically even if your
passcode is not as strong as we've just
seen one of these six quadrillion
possibilities well what could we do
instead well as anyone and I'll zoom in
on this here accidentally locked themsel
out of their own phone before like when
does that happen yeah when you try the
password too many times yeah so too many
times maybe your finger's slightly off
maybe you're slightly off and you just
don't input the same passcode correctly
after like five times 10 times there's
some reasonable threshold and why does
that happen well Apple and Google
equivalently figure just
probabilistically if after 10 guesses
you still haven't typed in the right
passcode probably you're not you you're
someone else who's picked up your phone
so we're just going to go ahead and lock
you out now what's the effect of this
well this means now that each of those
possible passcodes no longer takes
roughly 1 second now it takes roughly 1
minute so the attack is still the same
but if it's now one passcode or 10
guesses per minute we have significantly
by a factor of 60 in this story slowed
things down and unfortunately does
anyone know what happens if you screw up
again after a
minute yeah it goes longer it's like
five minutes and then 10 minutes and uh
Google is kind of obnoxious about it
they don't even give you a time frame
they just say try again later and so
that keeps not only the adversary out
but also potentially you so there in
lies that trade-off if you've forgotten
your code if nowadays your finger is
slightly wet so the screen isn't
responding correctly these could be
usability downsides too so security is
really just about finding The Sweet Spot
among these various tradeoffs here but
there's other mechanisms too and some of
you might recognize this screen from
Gmail via which of course you log in but
after you log into Gmail or similar
websites or apps or systems at work
nowadays especially you might be
presented with uh what's called
two-factor authentication and what is
this in a nutshell in Lay person
terms most many of you if you do
anything digitally at work might have to
do this now
yeah exactly you get texted at your
phone an additional code that's not your
same password it's typically a numeric
code maybe six digits long it expires
after a minute or 10 minutes but why is
this a good thing well one it's no
longer just a piece of information that
you know or that you might have written
down it's information that changes every
time you try to log in but more
importantly it's a fundamentally second
factor which means it's not just
something you know now it's something
you have so you for instance are the
only one theoretically that should be
receiving that code and so now the
adversary if they want to get into your
account not only have to guess or brute
force or maybe read off of a Post-It
note your password they also have to
physically have access now to that phone
so there's still a threat absolutely but
it's not everyone on the internet with
an internet connection now it's only the
people in Starbucks now it's only the
people at work now it's only the people
in your home who might have access to
that second Factor so there too it just
raises the bar to the adversary making
it harder more timec consuming more
geographically impossible for them to
attack you but what's the downside of
two-factor authentication whether it's a
device or even nowadays it's in software
whether it's on your keychain or on your
phone where you're prompted for this
code what's a downside as some of us
have probably experienced
too forg you forget your cell phone
absolutely right the the factor that you
have you don't have with you or maybe
you're in a basement somewhere don't
have reception you're on a plane you
can't get the code and so there too are
these tradeoffs and even it departments
need to keep that in mind because what
does that mean for them well if you
don't have your phone with you and you
are in the habit of calling it to help
you fix this now there's a a cost a
human cost maybe even a financial cost
and so it policy nowadays is really just
about finding the right balance and
where we want to spend our resources but
at least raise the bar to the adversary
but of course there's other ways too and
this is going to be one of our homework
assignments if you will after today
there's this software called password
managers and no need to buzz in on your
phone but maybe with a physical hand how
many folks here use a password manager
okay let me ballpark this at 10 20%
perhaps Okay so we've got 80% upside
here and a lesson learned potentially so
a password manager is just a piece of
software on your Mac your PC or your
phone nowadays that manages your
passwords well what is that mean when
you go to a website for the first time
or you download an app for the first
time and you have to create an account
you can can still use your email address
or David as your username or whatever
your name might be so you don't have to
change that methodology but instead of
typing in one 2 3 4 5 six as your same
password for that website or app as well
as for every other now you use the
password manager software to generate
something difficult to guess for you
that is you tell the password manager
give me an8 character random passcode
not 0000 but something with punctuation
with numbers with letters and better yet
the password manager is the name
suggests remembers that password for you
and the next time you go to another
website you do it again with a
completely different password maybe same
username maybe two-factor authentication
but different password different
password different password and it
doesn't have to be eight I mean I'm in
the habit of using a dozen two dozen
characters in total and at that point I
can't even pronounce the number of
possibilities because it goes well be
Beyond uh the quadrillions so the
probability that someone's going to get
into one of those accounts for me now is
very very very low and they're going to
take less interest in me and maybe more
interest in someone else that's not
using as good of a password now what
does this mean in real terms well when
you go to log into that managed site you
don't manually type your password
anymore in fact you don't generally even
need to know it nowadays I probably
don't know 90 plus 99% of my passwords I
entrust them to this password manager
now of course you'd like to think that
the password manager itself is secure so
what might that mean well those of you
who do use a password manager how do you
access that software itself what's
protecting your data in your
understanding so maybe Biometrics like
your your face ID or maybe your
fingerprint or maybe more simply what
else password maybe just a password and
hopefully that password that primary
password that gatekeeper is not itself 1
2 3 4 5 6 otherwise it doesn't matter
how secure all of the others are but if
you're willing to put in the effort and
pick one pretty long somewhat random
very unguessable password that you just
promise to commit to memory and maybe
for backup you literally print it out
and put it in a safe deposit box or a
safe or just kind of hide it somewhere
physically that there's very low
probability someone's going to find the
backup copy that might be Al loan but of
course the flip side is now if you
forget that Ma that primary password
you've now lost all of the eggs in the
basket if someone gets that primary
password now they have access to
everything so that's rather the
trade-off but I dare say you're probably
less threatened depending on your family
uh uh by the people immediately around
you than the billions of other people on
the internet that have access
potentially to those same systems so
there to it's a trade-off and it's up to
you to decide whether or not to manage
your passwords in this way but if you
were on that top 10 list or even if
you're not but you can think of several
accounts that all have the same password
you're probably going to benefit from
something like this and why is it bad to
be clear to use the same password on
multiple sites in case that's never sort
of dawned
in thought why is that a bad thing to
reuse a password on different websites
different apps any intuition yeah and
back exactly once it's attacked you can
the adversary presumably by transitivity
can see oh well if this user's username
is mailin harvard.edu on this website
and their password is foolishly 1 2 3 4
56 or even something way more
complicated they can probably just
assume with high probability that if I'm
being a little reckless let's try access
mailin at harvard.edu other accounts
other apps using that exact same
password and so by transitivity
essentially you're putting your other uh
Accounts at risk so what's maybe a
takeaway minimally here I would start to
reconsider your passcodes on your most
important data Maybe it's medical maybe
it's Financial maybe it's email anything
remotely personal that you really
wouldn't want to have access uh do you
necessarily need the same form level of
security on eCommerce sites or sites
that you don't really care about or that
you signed up for once and after that H
that's it probably not so you can decide
for yourself but again software like a
password manager and these are just some
of the possibilities out there um are
probably to be your friend a couple of
these are free they come with Windows or
Mac OS a couple are commercial Harvard
has a site license for students for uh
one of these as well so there are
options out there but what else do
people use what else can people use to
keep their system secure so most of us
nowadays have probably heard of
encryption this technique for just kind
of scrambling information so when you
want to send a message an email or
upload a a photograph or use your credit
card hopefully it's not just being sent
out for all to see but there's some kind
of scrambling going on and some fancy
mathematics ensure that encryption
ensures that only you the sender and
someone else the receiver can
theoretically see what that credit card
number is what that message is what that
photograph is instead so encryption is
sort of Common Place nowadays both in
websites and apps and ATMs and other
such devices but how does it work well
back in week two of cs50 uh your child
learned learned a little something about
encryption otherwise known as
cryptography and one of the algorithms
we talked about was quite simply
something like this this is what we
might call uh not only cs50 but plain
text so very plain text that in this
case is English and obviously everyone
in the room can read it but what if I
wanted to send this message out to
someone in this room or out on the
Internet or maybe equivalently back in
the day maybe write a message down on a
scrap of paper in grade school and pass
a secret note a secret love note to
someone in class with hopes that the
teach or any other students in the class
can't intercept it and read it well you
probably don't want to say this is cs50
or I love you or anything remotely
sensitive but rather maybe you want to
encrypt it and let's change the the T to
a u maybe change the H to an i the I to
a j the S to a t the I to a j the S to a
t again the C to a d the S to a T and
we'll just leave the numbers alone even
though I worry someone could probably
guess what this now does say nonetheless
but what was the algorithm as I rattled
those ch changes off whether student
from week two or parent from week now
yeah a on shift just a onlet shift and
this is more sophisticatedly called a
rotational Cipher or a Caesar Cipher
after Caesar back in the day it's
relatively simplistic but back in the
day it's not so simplistic if you're the
first person in the world to ever use it
or think of it but nowadays this is not
actually what we use but it's similarly
mathematical in nature it's not quite as
simple as just adding one or subtracting
one to go from now what we'd call text
to plain test but it's similarly math
that's involved and let me just
stipulate that the way the math works is
that the sender and the receiver just
have to have in mind some kind of secret
and the Secret in this case would very
trivially be one but it could be a much
bigger much more unguessable number or
maybe some other secret we share the
presumption being that my classmates my
teacher in that grade school classroom
if they don't know what that secret is
that number is yeah they could try to
brute force it and try all possible
mathematics plus one plus 2 plus three
but that's going to take them some time
and they probably don't care enough and
so my data might be therefore relatively
secure but we use encryption all the
time nowadays and so for instance this
is at the start of most URLs nowadays
even if you don't type it yourself with
that said Safari and even Chrome now or
kind of simplifying if not dumbing down
user interfaces to just hide details
that you and I as sort of normal users
don't need to see 24/7 but it is there
and if in fact on your phone or laptop
you click on the URL even if it's super
short initially you'll probably see the
whole thing starting with this and the s
means secure the s means that encryption
is being used but there's other forms of
this not just when you visit websites
there's this endtoend encryption which
is being talked about more nowadays
especially during coid times with so
many more of us on video and talking
about uh more sensitive things tele
medicine talking to doctors things that
you also wouldn't want to verbally or
visually get out into the wild just like
text what's different about endtoend
encryption versus HTT GPS and the type
of encryption that most of us use every
day on websites
alone end to end encryption is sort of a
better feature that you want to
increasingly seek when using services
like Zoom or Microsoft teams or Whatsapp
or the
like any instincts here yeah over on the
right good so the encryption the
scrambling of information happens in The
Source the sender and the destination
the receiver without a so-called
middleman in between and this is
actually very different from most
contexts nowadays that use just https
because when you're using https to buy
something on Amazon securely with your
credit card well of course Amazon needs
to be able to decrep the message at the
end of the day and so that's fine but
even when you're using services like
video conferencing or maybe text
messaging nowadays well if you're using
Whatsapp that's owned by meta and if
you're using Instagram that's owned by
meta there's a lot of middlemen in these
apps that we're using and if they were
only using encryption period or only
using something like https yes your en
your connection from you to WhatsApp and
in turn to the recipient might very well
be secure on each end of that channel
but meta in the between the company and
any other company in between could
theoretically For Better or For Worse be
looking at that data whether it's to
mine it for advertising purposes whether
it's to Snoop on data that you're
sending that is not end to-end
encryption if the middleman a company
typically has technically access to that
data now zoom and Microsoft teams and
WhatsApp and iMessage and other services
with which you're familiar increasingly
are offering stronger guarantees of
encryption whereby it's indeed between
parties A and B and not the one in the
middle now there's downsides here and
you can actually see this kind of
functionality manifest in certain
settings for instance besides iMessage
uh which just does this for you on
iPhones or Macs besides Zoom um you can
actually fine-tune these settings indeed
within Zoom itself s so here's a
screenshot that I took last night of
just what the user interface looks like
today to create a new Zoom meeting with
the latest version of Zoom software and
maybe unbeknownst to you there's a
choice of buttons down here and most
likely yours is by default on enhanced
encryption which is brilliant marketing
speak because it's just encryption it's
not enhanced it actually ironically
means worse than this um but they want
you using it most likely why well it's a
little easier to implement it's a little
less expensive for them computationally
and to be fair enhanced encryption does
scramble the data but not in a way that
Zoom can't see it Zoom can indeed see it
but that's actually a plus in some
context because if you want to do like
Cloud recordings and you want a meeting
recorded not on your Mac or PC but like
let Zoom deal with that if you want
automatic transcription nowadays so the
words to appear whether it's English or
something else on the screen well you
can't really lock Zoom or any other
middleman out of that because someone
needs to save it to the cloud someone
needs to translate the voice to those
English or some other language words so
enhanced encryption enables those
features but they also allow a bad actor
malicious employee someone who's just
nosy at Zoom or the equivalent middleman
to just kind of poke around your video
conference and hear what you've said or
see what you've typed as well unless you
instead check this box as well so
increasingly look for mentions of end
to-end encryption or give that some
thought when you choose a technology via
which to communicate with someone
whether it's within your family or
without as well now last but not least
there's other applications of encryption
too and this too might be a lesson
learned as well full dis encryption so a
dis is like where your data stored in
your Mac or PC or even your phone and
full dis encryption just means ideally
that all of your data is encrypted that
is somehow scrambled now hopefully your
password for your computer or phone is
good enough that even though the device
is encrypted with that password at least
you'll remember it and your phone or
your Mac or PC will automatically
decrypt it for you of course you can't
scramble the information and hide it
from from ourselves one of us at least
for these devices needs to have access
but full dis encryption typically means
that at least when you close the laptop
lid or power down for the night that
even if someone else steals that device
opens the lid unless they don't unless
they have your passcode they can't even
plug in fancy cables to the device and
just rip the zeros and ones off of the
device and see what's actually there
full dis encryption means they could do
that but they would just see seemingly
random zeros and ones now there's a
downside here too this might slow things
down potentially but it is a feature
increasingly that's offered and is
absolutely something you should consider
enabling um in general especially if
your laptop or phone travels with you
and certainly your phone does or if you
plan to donate or sell or give away a
device you don't want to leave all of
the zeros and ones the remnants of your
own sensitive data passed on there so
Windows has a feature called bit Locker
Mac OS has a feature called file Vault
there's commercial options as well but
generally we're at the point now in 2022
we're clicking a button is suff
efficient to enable these features with
that said don't rush into all of these
decisions I would make backups of your
data and don't maybe email cs50 if
something goes wrong with that process
but I would do your own due diligence
but this too would be a menu of
possibilities and now the bad side the
downside of what seems to be great this
notion of full dis encryption
unfortunately just as we can encrypt our
data to protect it from the adversaries
so can the adversaries if they get into
our devices encrypt our data and do what
not tell us that secret key and so this
is generally applied in the context of
ransomware which tragically you
increasingly hear about in Hospital
Systems school systems municipalities
where systems are getting attacked and
the data is not just getting stolen
because what is the adversary typically
need with like local municipal or even
Hospital data the value to the adversary
is encrypting all of the hospital all of
the mpali data preventing them from
accessing it if they have no backups or
the like and so ransomware is liter
Lally about trying to convince someone
to pay you money or pay you Bitcoin or
something like that to give you that
secret key and this key in this case is
surely more sophisticated than the
number one but it's really the same idea
so here too yet again a trade-off just
as we sort of invent something for good
it can also be used for evil and so to
speak as well but it's really the same
underlying principles even though we
keep seeing it and hearing about it in
these different forms and lastly if only
because folks are generally familiar but
don't necessarily know what it is that
it's doing for them browsers nowadays
have what's often called incognito mode
or private mode which has nothing to do
with encryption but does have to do with
cyber security or really cyber privacy
keeping your data from prying eyes uh
incognito mode if you open it in Chrome
for instance looks a little something
like this and we use it in cs50 when
introducing students as we did last week
to web programming because it in effect
lets you start with a clean slate like a
brand new browser that has never visited
any websites before which is good for
just diagnosing problems but it's often
commonly used if you want to log into
maybe your Gmail account on someone
else's computer and you don't want your
password being saved or you want to
visit some website where you don't want
the URL or the Search terms ending up in
your autocomplete history so there's
multiple uses for incognito mode but
what does it really do well it doesn't
stop your company it doesn't stop your
University your internet service
provider be it Comcast Verizon or the
like from knowing what websites you go
to because ask your student a couple
weeks ago we talked about actually a
week ago we talked about how the
internet works and unfortunately
computer has an IP address which is
unique identifier which goes out anytime
you go anywhere incognito mode or not so
this isn't really covering your tracks
outside of your office or outside of
your home or outside of your company but
it is at least throwing away local
information and so we'll talk in fact in
cs50 is week nine this coming Monday
about cookies which you might generally
know about and what are called sessions
and so long story short what incognito
mode does is it throws away when you
close the window any locally stored
information to the these things called
cookies which are sort of like virtual
handstamps that just remember what
you've logged in as or what's in your
shopping cart or the like but it doesn't
hide any information from anyone outside
of your own Mac or PC it only prevents
those local prying eyes so there too
even though we have tools that many of
you are probably in the habit of using
or thinking you should use to um be more
private be more secure on the internet
what we do really in cs50 boast week's
uh past and future is talk about how
these Technologies work so that
ultimately we have all the more of an
educated citizenry um here among
undergrads and here as well as on line
so that you can apply these same Lessons
Learned to problems you'll encounter in
the future so as promised the homework
one should probably use a password
manager doesn't have to be one of those
ones on the list but at least starting
that conversation maybe with someone who
does maybe the you know it's often the
you know the the the student in your
family perhaps who can advise you on
some of these Technologies consider
using a password manager to using
two-factor authentication whether it's
your phone or some key fob or or the
like but at least seeking out that
feature at least for accounts that you
really care about your email social
media Financial medical anything where
you'd be embarrassed at best or really
violated at worst if that kind of
information got out and then
increasingly using not just encryption
which you kind of get automatically for
most Technologies today but increasingly
choosing technologies that offer
stronger guarantees that keep those
middlemen those companies out of the way
if only so that you can trust with
higher probability that only party B
knows what party a has said or sent now
this of course was a whirlwind tour
there's so much more that you can do
online indeed this course cs50 can be
taken for free online via platforms like
edex at edx.org cs50 I thought it might
be appropriate to end on this note if
anyone would like to conjecture before
we start playing music and adjourn for
lunch what our final message here
is if we reverse the plus one and maybe
start minus one here minus one here and
indeed thank you so much for coming this
was
[Applause]
[Music]
cs50